this massive flutter course will take
you from being an absolute beginner to
being able to release apps on the google
play store and the app store bandit is a
very experienced software developer and
an excellent teacher hello everyone and
welcome to this free flota course my
name is vandal and i'm a google
developer expert for flutter and dart
and let's jump and jump right in who's
this course for i designed this course
mainly for absolute beginners so whoever
hasn't even done a written a single line
of code before i actually when designing
this course i designed it for two
specific personas one was a graphic
designer who was working mainly with
figma
actually it doesn't really matter what
graphical tool you're using photoshop
or figma or whatever or sketch
and the other persona was a project
manager who's mainly working with jira
so um i've made the assumption that you
pretty much don't know anything about
software development from before and
even if you're a software developer you
could perhaps jump over the things that
you might know but if you haven't done a
flutter development from before i
strongly suggest that you actually
follow the chapters chronologically
which is the way i've designed this
course basically
so um as i mentioned i want when i
design this course i want i wanted
everybody to just follow the chapters
one at a time and one after each other
chronologically so um i highly recommend
that you don't jump over chapters just
because there's so much information
provided in each chapter and i will be
referring back to information that i
provided in previous chapters in each
chapter so i think it's very good if you
can just follow the course the way i
design it to be consumed which is
chronologically
and what you learn in this course is not
only the basics but you'll also go from
a complete beginner to being able to
release your
applications in apple's app store and
google's play store and we're going to
be using a
blend of different tools and software
we're going to be using visual studio
code we're using firebase for the
backend which i'll teach you all about
we're using even figma as a graphic
designer to create our icons and
screenshots and even
our
loading screens so and there's lots to
be learned and i'll take you through
those steps and i don't make any
assumptions about what you may know from
before so i'll explain everything along
the way so you'll go from absolute
beginner to be able to be able to
actually release your two applications
which is the same code base in apple's
app store and google's play store
uh if you if you're attending this
course please do follow me on social
media and i'll really really appreciate
it i'm evan.mp on twitter and also you
can find me by my full name on linkedin
that'd be much appreciated this course
of course uh for free
but for those who want to and are able
to
support me um then you can do that by
buying me a cup of coffee on
buy me a coffee.com van that so without
further ado let's just jump right into
it
hello everyone and welcome
to the first chapter of our flutter
course
um
there are so many different topics that
i could choose for the first chapter
they're
and they're all very important
however after going through the material
that i've been preparing for you for
this course i realized that one of the
absolute basic points that we have to go
through is the developer accounts
um
for apple and google now if you're not
familiar with the term of developer
account there
are
basically what a developer account
allows you to do is to release your
applications on um apple's app store and
google's play store
as i mentioned in the introduction
you may choose to follow along this
course
without actually releasing the
application to the app store and the
play store
but
even if you do decide to not release the
applications
on the aforementioned stores you will
still
for the optimal experience of
development for ios and android you will
most definitely need a developer account
and
the reason behind that is
i mean it is quite deep to try to
explain the actual reason behind it
but
from my perspective one of the most
important reasons you may want to have a
developer account is to create the
so-called
app ids
so every application on ios and every
application on android has
an identifier which is usually something
called a reverse domain identifier and
it's kind of like um
i still find it strange
the way it is but
some were somehow it was decided that
every application needs to have an
identifier and every identifier is kind
of like associated with a domain name
and a domain name is kind of like a
website for instance if you have
a
yourname.com uh as your website
then
you would say that okay i'm gonna create
an application for ios and android in
flutter and i'm gonna call it fubar
then
it was somehow decided that your
applications identifier would then in
that case be
if you reverse it
then it would literally be your domain
in reverse which would become
dot
your name dot
your application's name
i don't really know
i mean if somebody's
if somebody knows the reasoning behind
it i would be glad to hear that and i'm
sure that there's resources out there
explaining why that is the case but it
kind of feels like it's become
the
norm
and we just have to roll with it
so
the reason i explained the app
identifier
is that
when you set up your back end later when
we set up the back end later together
in that the client that we write in
flutter is going to talk with our
backend and store the notes retrieve the
notes create a user
uh sign in with a user etc etc
that back-end
setup also will require you to have your
app identifier
and
even though you don't necessarily need
to have a developer account to get an
app identifier because an app identifier
is just something that you decide
okay here's my app identifier i think my
website is called this
blah blah and even though you don't
actually need a website that's the thing
but an app identifier is usually
associated with a website so don't worry
about it
you don't have to have a website in
order to follow along with these steps
that i'm going to name here
but it is still good practice to create
your developer account in order to
officially register
your app identifiers
and
another reason that you will need
a developer account for apple and google
is that you will
for apple
um
if you want to be able to
deploy your application
onto a telephone
and not use a simulator
then you will need to register a
developer account and
use some resources that apple provides
you in forms of certificates and keys
and profiles
in order to deploy your application to a
telephone or an ipad for instance
and android the world is a little bit
different in that you don't have to do
the same process but
in order to then submit your application
to google for
review
later so that it can be available for
everybody who has an android telephone
or a tablet you will still need a
developer account so
it goes without saying that it is a very
important step
um
that even if you decide
not to
deploy your application later to app
store and play store
it's still a very fundamental step so
i suggest that you actually go through
these steps that i'm gonna provide you
in the first chapter
and that's why i actually decided to
have this as chapter one
um
sorry i have to just edit my notes a
little bit
if you haven't watched the introduction
to this course and you're just jumping
here i suggest that you go to the
introduction and watch it i know it was
about 34 minutes it was quite a long
introduction but there are so many
important points that i feel everybody
needs to know before you get started
with the course so please watch those if
you see me moving my head around then
you know the reason
and i explain a lot of things
that are like the fundamentals of this
course
and the reasoning
all those decisions which i believe are
so important that i still suggest
everybody watched an introduction before
they actually start with the course so
so
we've now talked about
the basics
um and if you go to
why we need a developer account i
believe i've already covered this
in that a developer account is
the utility is an account that you
register for apple and google
that gives you extra resources as a
developer in order to be able to deploy
your application and deploy your
applications to the respective
app stores
now
if we talk about
developer accounts
there are two main types of developer
accounts one is an individual account
and the other one is a company account
um
and
for me the biggest difference between
these two different accounts is the
liability
um and by liability i mean
if you
if you register an individual account
then you as an individual are liable for
that application and as users download
your application and interact with it if
they have any problems any for instance
any
there's any judiciary problems
like if
if someone for some reason believes that
you're storing their data in the wrong
way or that you're storing their
personal information without exposing
that and telling the users about that
then they can personally hold you liable
for
for for instance breach of information
or gdpr
infringements or whatever it is so
just know that you can register yourself
as an individual for
both
app store apple's app store and google's
play store
but you need to also be aware that
should you wish to do that then you're
personally liable for any problems that
will
that may be
[Music]
occurring in the future so that's the
personal account
or an individual account and as a
company account then
uh
you kind of like
based on what type of company you've
created
um
you may or may not be personally liable
for
um
any damages that may be caused to your
users and if they bring it up to you now
i know this is all sounding a lot
serious
in reality what we are trying to do is
not that big a deal but we are still
trying to store i mean the goal of this
course is to um at this course is to
uh
go through
an application and create an application
that can store users notes notes can be
quiet personal
and you're storing those notes then um
on a backhand that you have full access
to
so you're kind of like storing user
created data
so it is very important that you
actually treat that data correctly make
sure that nobody
except those who are authorized
can access that data so
um
from a responsibility
point of view it is actually
a little bit different
what kind of
company account you want to create if
that's what you want to create now
because for instance in sweden where i
live
you can have
a personal company account in that or
sorry a personal company so you can
register a personal company it means
that you are personally liable for that
company
um
and you can also create a company that
uh
it has like uh
it's like an umbrella basically sits on
top and then there are people who are
directors of the company and blah blah
so you're not personally liable
uh
and that is the same structure that you
can find in many other countries
i believe you asked germany
sweden
england
and many other countries you can set up
companies that are
either a sole
proprietorship or something called
english is not my first language but
it's something like that or you can
create like a limited company that you
have limited liability and you're not
personally liable so
these are the different types of
developer accounts that you can set up
so
we can i mean that point i think we all
understand now that you can create an
individual or a company account
now
i think i mean i personally registered
already an account
as an ios developer and an android app
developer so
and since i registered a company account
i can't go through setting up the exact
same company again
but at least i can show you some of the
steps involved
in creating those
accounts
so what we could do is to um
now you can't see the screen right now
but i will bring it up here
so that you can also see
now i'm gonna bring my studio here
and i'm going to make this screen a
little bit bigger so that you can see my
screen better
so
let me also make this a little bit
smaller on top so that you can see
the content a little bit better
so you can see here that there are two
options available to you either you
enroll as an individual or you enroll as
an organization
and it is strongly recommended actually
um
so you need to make sure that you have
two-factor authentication turned on and
so that's that's not a problem all this
means basically as an individual it
means that just you you will need an
account you will need to set up an
account
however if you want to set up as an
organization like if you have a limited
company and you want to create an apple
developer account that is linked to that
organization is a little bit different
because
um
you will need to set up something called
addons or duns or i don't know how you
want to pronounce the uns
which is kind of like a
it's a new thing for me at least but it
is an identifier for your company that
you either have been assigned to already
um
by
i think there is a company called dmb
um
so if we go to let me see if i can bring
the notes for that
uh let's see
learn more if you go to learn more here
here
dmb
is called by done and bradstreet
so
there then we have uh the ability to
register a duns number
um
for me i was one of the lucky people to
have already been assigned a duns number
for my company
um
by dmb
because you either have um let's see if
if they write it here
you see it says dmv may have already
assigned your organization a free uh
duan's number
before enrolling look up your
organization to see if you have a duns
number so you can just click on the link
and we can go here
and
you can then select your region for me
it would be sweden then i would write my
company name
some address information contact
information etc etc
and then you can check
whether there is a duns number assigned
to your company so i suggest that you
actually do this by going to this
website
okay
so that's for a duns number if you
already have one but if you don't have
one then you will have to create
and request a duans number from dnb
i would show you the website for dmb and
the uns number right now but
my browser is set up so that my locale
is already provided to the browser which
is swedish and then if i go to the dmv
website you're gonna see everything in
swedish
and that doesn't make any sense just to
read the information in swedish but
i believe you can go to dmb's website um
so if
if i search for a dmb
duns or dunes or here so this is a
swedish
localized website for dmb
let's see if it can change the language
um
actually i can see here that they're
very they're actually in sweden
and i wonder if we can here change
country
let's just say
international
so
if we go here
let's see if he can um
if there's any way to actually request a
duns number
like if he sir say b-u-n-s
um
and i can't see anything related to that
to be honest with you so if you go back
here
i can see i can request the duns and
here the locale is svse
and here the locale was engb
so what happens if we just go back to
this url that we were on before
and then i just change the locale
does that work
well unfortunately but
i mean here the uns number
um
get a duns number okay that's good
and then and you can hear say i'm an
apple developer
press continue
oh it sends you back here
um
that was really bad
so
it says look up your organization
in apple's website
uh
and when you
when you try to get a uns number
it tells you to go to apple's website
um
if we say that then okay legal business
name etc etc okay
so you will you will need to go through
this process which doesn't seem to be
completely easy
to get a duns number you see requested
the uns number so you probably just want
to go to dmb.coms
number.html
and i i can't explain this complete
process to be honest with you because
first of all it will be a waste of time
for both of us
uh because these are so many moving
parts and a third-party company that i
have no control over so if i even try to
explain their process it may change
tomorrow so there's
it's not a good investment of our time
but everybody else has figured it out
and i'm pretty sure that if you just go
and say request the uns number you can
just
follow the process and then
get your uns number but begin by going
through
look up your organization
so
you may already have been assigned a
free duns number so
do that first please but but if you have
to request the uns number i believe
there is a little bit of a cost to it
and that is about 70 dollars if i'm 70
to 80 dollars at the time of recording
this video
so
count with almost about a hundred
dollars and
hopefully not more
uh hopefully actually a lot less about
around um
70 dollars at least
does that make sense i said so many
numbers seventy dollars at least
so um
try to get your duns number at least
that that's what apple says you will
need
now of course if you want to register
as a company i can't stress this enough
you will need a website
i remember vividly when i registered
a developer account at apple
and they rejected my request saying that
well
your website doesn't have any content
and they were right because i just
created an empty website like a domain i
regis i know i didn't actually create an
empty website i registered a domain
and there was no website so when you
typed my website's name it was it would
just not show you anything so
um and they came back and said no your
application is rejected because you
don't have a website what kind of
company are you
so then i had to actually get like a
hosting service and i have some content
in there have like a support
so if you are registering as
a website sorry as a company as an
organization you will need a hosting
service you will need a domain provider
uh
you will need to ensure that you have a
website because they're not the same
thing if you have a host
and you have a domain provider it still
doesn't mean that you have content
on your web page but what i realize is
that if you
register your domain and have hosting
service make sure that you have a
website just have some
content in there say hello we are this
business that business
um
we work with this and this if you have
any questions contact this email and
here's our phone number here's their
address etc so you need to ensure that
if you have
an organization it is actually an
organization it's not just like hi my
name is fubar i'm sitting at home
contact me if you have any questions not
like that
so
and of course after you made your
decision you start the enrollment
process so
now
learn more continue enrollment on the
web you can do
and then you come here and you will
basically need to provide your
information
and continue with the process now we're
not going to go through this but
the important thing i have to mention
here is that as
you
go through the enrollment process as a
an apple developer unfortunately there
is a cost
uh last time which is about a few months
ago when i registered or i had to renew
my registration you have to renew your
registration
for
apple's developer account you have to
renew it every year
and
as i've mentioned here the
process is not free unfortunately it
costs
or
last time i registered or renewed my
registration it costs 99 and i believe
it's been 99 for a very long time so if
you're in sweden it costs about a
thousand
crowns if you're in england it probably
costs about 80 pounds or something
um and in the us it's about yeah just
count with almost a hundred dollars so
i used to be able to provide this like
you have to have some sort of credit
card or debit card to be able to pay for
it so
um after you've done that after you
register your account as an organization
you will have direct access then
or an immediate access to your developer
account and you can start developing
applications etc etc etc so
if you're following along with this um
course and you want to deploy your
application to the app store and play
store please do this first
get your developer account either as an
organization or as a
as an individual
get that process out of the way because
a developer account especially if you're
an organization as i mentioned here is
not a super fast process i mean when you
get the account then it's simple it's
fast and you're in there immediately but
the process itself is a long process so
um i remember for me it took about two
weeks because i got one rejection took
about one week for them to renew like to
review the process the documents again
so
is not a fast process uh unfortunately
it's like very
it's yeah it's just long long
boring process so
get that out of the way if you can
please
um
so
that's for
the
long and not free part
for ios
and
also
one more thing that i need to mention is
that
if you're registering and you want to
sell applications which is not the
purpose of this course but if you want
to sell applications then you will have
to provide some banking
and tax information
so they need to ensure that the stuff
that you're selling in different
countries the money that is
then being sent to your bank account
will be accounted for when you're paying
your taxes
so and i believe that if you're trying
to sell
apps on the app store then you will have
to fill in some forms with the u.s tax
offices um
i don't even remember irs i think
internal revenue services or something
like the irs i believe that you have to
fill some forms like send the forms to
them then they will come back with some
sort of identifier to you and then you
will need to use that identifier
on apple's website in order to basically
say that yeah yeah i know i'm selling
stuff in the u.s i'm selling stuff in
japan i'm selling stuff in sweden norway
but i'm
gonna pay taxes for them here in my
country and that's what the form says
here
here is my name here's my company
i'm an organization or i'm an individual
so i have no company
my
personal identification number my
country is this
um is my address my phone number etc and
then you send it to them
to irs and then they come back and say
okay now we know who you are and here is
your um
identifier number like a business
identifier number bin or something they
call it i think i don't remember exactly
but i believe depending on whether
you're a business or an individual then
the number is a little bit different
so if you're a business i think it's bin
and if you're an individual is in i
don't know
so
um i don't know what that dialogue was
some bluetooth devices wants to connect
to my computer i don't know what it is
so
that's that part it can be long and it's
not free okay
that was a lot of information um
that's for ios
now uh what we can do now is to talk a
little bit about android as well
and
the good thing about the android process
like setting up your account for
as a google developer is that it's a lot
more straightforward as you would expect
from google and given that they're um
even like
sending updates to an android app to the
google developer console is a lot more
straightforward than it is for ios i
don't want to scare you but it is a fact
and you will know that later when we
actually get to the end of this course
where we release the apps
for ios and android that it is a little
bit more straightforward for google
play store
but you still need to sign up for a
developer account
so
um
i'm gonna take in my notes uh that i've
talked about that
so
what we also need to know is that there
is a url that we can go to
i'm going to copy that and paste it over
here so you see which one i'm talking
about
here
then you can see that you can set up a
developer account and once you've logged
in so i'm assuming that you're logged in
then you go to play.google.com slash
console slash user or you zero sign up
is where url it may change
so let's just
what you can do is just google
google play console developer account or
google developer account then you will
end up in a url that looks kind of like
this so
so don't count with this url that i
mentioned here because it may change
that's what i'm saying and
you can as it is for ios development you
can either set it up personally as an
individual or you can set up as an
organization now i
happen to have set it up for myself as
an organization because i do have a
company here in sweden so it is a lot
easier for me to tie all my business
relations with apple and google into one
entity which is my developer account for
sorry which is my company
so
it wouldn't make so much sense for me to
explain this either to go through all
the details but if you want to set it up
for yourself as an individual just press
on get started or if you want to set it
as an organization just press get
started there as you can see you can
provide information about your
organization and you can see here as
well as soon as you say i'm an
organization then they say okay what's
the website
so
uh you can see if i don't have a website
we recommend adding a website that
represents your organization well
kind of makes sense i mean if you're a
company where's your website every
company should have a website unless
you're like a pizza restaurant or
something even a pizza restaurant
probably needs a website but we have a
pizza restaurant here in our town that
doesn't have website so
they're on facebook um
and you don't you probably don't want to
say that your company's website is on
facebook so
um
so yeah
where are we here
and if you say you're an individual then
you come here
and they ask for some other stuff
but still interesting because
it says enter the url of your website or
social media profile
uh so here you kind of have to need
you kind of need to enter that as well
so maybe you can get away with a
facebook url i laughed about it but
maybe you can get away with it i don't
know
but i don't recommend that to be honest
with you because as you will see later
in the course when we actually submit
our apps to app store and play store
there are a few key
data points that you have to provide to
both stores one is a privacy policy url
and the other one
is a support url
um
and there are also two
other
emails you have to provide
so yeah four
the emails the first one is
the support email and the other one is a
contact email and if you're if you're
setting up a business account
then i really suggest that you actually
set up a website because if you set up a
website and you have a domain you have
an email provider then your email will
kind of be like uh
foobar at
mybusiness.com it's a lot more
professional to set up an email that is
bound to that it's connected to your
email to your domain than it is to say
mr johnson gmail.com
um
i wouldn't trust a business that has a
gmail.com
account
i kind of want to know that yeah here's
a serious business that they have their
own website and blah blah blah
but on the contrary
setting up a website setting up some
emails doesn't necessarily mean you're
serious either so
but it makes it more dedicated if you
know what i mean so
um
so yeah
that's um
the process for setting up an account
also for as an android
developer i think that's that's about it
uh that's all i wanted to mention in
this uh first chapter of our course uh
i highly recommend that you get your
developer accounts for apple and for
google
what you'll also need to know is that
i mean i've talked a lot about now apple
account and a google developer account
but
if you're if you're developing uh your
application
on a windows machine for instance if
you're if you're trying to learn how to
develop flutter applications and you
don't care about releasing your
application at all
you don't have to do any of this
just follow along with the course as
usual no problem
but if you're
if you want to actually release your
application for ios then you
most definitely need to also have a mac
because you can't build your application
otherwise there are some tricks you can
do you can like
build your
photo application then later on like a
friend's macintosh if they have one or
you can send to a service that's in the
cloud and they build the app for you and
then they will send it back to you and
then you can submit it so
or maybe they even have to submit it
it's a bit hairy to be honest with you
but
um
it's it's a complicated topic it is a
little bit difficult to explain
um
for instance if you're on a windows
machine you can't even have xcode xcode
is the tool
and the the entire like a chain of
tool sets that gets installed on a
macintosh in order to build
an application for ios platform
now why am i talking about this and
the reasoning behind that is that if
you're developing a flutter application
then um
flutter
can be deployed on a windows machine um
macintosh or collectively called as
desktop
web android ios five platforms at the
moment
and
if you're trying to
release your application and build it
for ios for instance and test on an
iphone or an ipad you can't do that on a
windows machine unfortunately that's not
there's nothing wrong with a windows
machine it's just apple's fault for
locking down their build systems and all
their tools to macintosh so they haven't
made the
[Music]
conscious decision
or
yeah they haven't made the decision to
bring their tool system and tooling to
windows unfortunately or linux
swift which is the language to write
native applications for ios
can be run i believe on linux um on
windows might be
but its main platform is still
mac
i know that this is a lot of information
also to learn but if there is anything i
want to
close this chapter the first chapter of
this course with is
you can learn flutter and follow along
with the steps i'm going to provide in
this course without having to register
any accounts yet so that's
point one
point two is that
you will need a macintosh if you want to
release if you want to comfortably build
and release your flutter app
for ios
if you
want to release your application on
google play store which is point three
if you want to do that you will need to
register a developer account on google
play console
as i've shown you here
and
i believe that's all that's all you need
to know so
some of you may already have all these
accounts and don't have to worry about
it
but some may not
know all this like if you're coming from
a design and design background if you
all you do is work with figma et cetera
and this is somebody for important
information that you'll need to know
about because i don't want you to get
like frustrated during the process
so i just want you to have some
information so that you can get started
at least without without too much hassle
all right that's it i think for
this
chapter i can take in my notes that i've
explained everything i want to explain
did take about 35 minutes
uh
it's not unexpected to be honest it's a
lot of information
and i kind of want to take my time with
it it's important that you
and for me as well to understand all
this
so great i think um that's it for this
video
so i'll see you in the next chapter
hi everyone and welcome to the second
chapter of our course now if you haven't
watched the introduction to this course
i really suggest that you do that before
continuing with the course because there
are so many points that i've explained
in that
introduction that i believe are so
important to understand before
continuing with the course so
in this chapter what we're going to do
is we're going to take care of some
setup steps that are required for
pretty much the
rest of
this course and all the other chapters
that follow along after this one chapter
3 4 and etc so
um we're going to talk about flutter
dart dark pad
and how to install flutter whether
you're on windows mac or
linux
and we're also going to talk about
xcode android studio and we're going to
talk about a few very useful
extensions to our code editor so
if you're coming from a background where
you haven't worked with any kind of
programming language before
um
i'm going to take this chapter quite
easy so if you're an advanced programmer
already you may want to skip this and
you already have like flutter install
everything you can skip this chapter
without a problem
so let's start by talking about
what flutter is
well traditionally developers and
programmers or software engineers
however you want to call them
they've been
creating and writing code with their
fingers
in
different languages and then they're
targeting different platforms it's very
important to understand what a language
programming language is um
versus a platform
think of a platform
as
the the end station where a software
ends up being run run on
so let's say windows is a platform mac
is a platform linux is a platform and
ios that runs on all iphones is a
platform android is a platform etc
now
you would have
programming languages
that
you as a software developer would use in
order to target those platforms to write
software for those platforms so you use
a programming language in order to write
a piece of code and be able to run that
code on that target platform okay
so a programming language example is
javascript python swift
rust
um what else is popular right now java
kotlin all these
these are
programming languages so
you as a software developer who's trying
to learn flutter would use then dart as
your program programming language as i
will soon explain
so
that has been the tradition that a
person sits in front of a computer and
says okay i want to write a program for
windows then they go and write some code
maybe with
csharp.net or
maybe they will just use some other
technology i don't know what's out there
right now for windows maybe they would
use vb.map
and
then they would be done and they will
release the software for windows and be
like okay i'm done now
then someone comes in the project and
says ah we need the same software for uh
macintosh or we need the same software
for
some other uh
for instance platform then you would
have to go and write the same
software
uh exact same code pretty much for the
other platform
so this process would be very repetitive
in that you would have to write the same
software over and over again so
things such as flutter came in in order
to remedy that so saying that a software
engineer sits at home or sits in the
office works with a group of other
people and a designer maybe or a few
designers ux there is a product owner
et cetera and then they would write the
same code then
which will then be run on different
platforms so as a software developer you
wouldn't have to maintain different
uh
very
similar pieces of code that only can be
run on one specific platform so
flutter in its ground basically is a ui
framework
for running beautiful
and writing beautiful applications that
run on multiple platforms at the same
time
developed by google has been in
production for a very long time it's uh
tried and tested it's open source
and if you don't
if you don't come from like software
engineering background open source
basically means that
the code that
is written
for flutter
basically the code that makes up plotter
is open to the public
for
uh finding bugs and also for
contributing to it or maybe just
learning from it so if you're for
instance coming from a background of as
a designer it's kind of like you have
your figma file open to the entire world
or your adobe xd source open to the
entire world for for them to watch what
you're doing as you're designing and
also for them to be able to fix stuff in
your design if they see it not working
as it should
so that's open source
um
so flutter is open source ui framework
um developed by google
what a framework means i mean if you're
not coming from a software engineering
background a framework is kind of like a
set of tools
uh provided to you
as a software developer so you can use
these tools take a bit of this one take
a bit of that one in order to produce an
output so
flutter it in itself is a software
but it's more precisely
referred to as a
as a framework because of it's a
collection of tools so if you hear a
framework just know oh there's a
collection of things i can use to
produce some output now
that's what flutter is um but
what powers flutter
is a programming language language
called dart and
dart has been in the making for more
than eight years is a language that at
the moment being maintained by google
and also is open source so anybody can
contribute to it anybody can learn from
it and and find exploits or maybe
problems with it and it will get patched
by the public or by google themselves
so dart is
the language the programming language
that powers flutter you could say
so
now you know what flutter is and now you
know what dart is
and i think in the next step now what we
can do is talk about
a great piece of
web software called dart pad
now
dark pad as i said is a web
software
or you could just call it a website
that allows you to run or write your
dart code
maybe pure dart code or
code for flutter
and run it directly in your browser
without you even having to install
anything so just open your browser and
as you will see soon we go to dark pad
and you will see how it looks like so
let me just
show you a little demonstration here so
here i have dart pad open
and i can actually increase the size so
you can see a little bit better
i may have to rearrange some components
here on the screen so you can see the
screen better
so i went to dartpad.dartlang.org
and you can see here that there is a
program written on the left hand side
and i can actually
yeah let this
what is dark dark pad allows you blah
blah text to be there so you can have
context of what i'm talking about
and you can see that the program is
sitting there and you are allowed then
to either change the program the way it
is
or click anywhere here to see
documentation down here
or press the run button so i'm just
going to press the run button and you
can see that
the text hello got printed to the screen
five times plus the
number of times it was actually printed
it's also printed on the screen so hello
one two three four five
so what you see on this side is the
source code
if you remember from open source so this
is a source code written in the
programming language called dart
and this is the output of that program
so
dark pad allows you to write text
here and just execute it and see the
results immediately
so
that's what dart is i mean sorry dark
pad is and we're going to talk
about dart and dark pad more in the in
the course but
right now what we should do is to start
by installing flutter
because
uh i mean you could say okay but flutter
is just the
uh
ui framework how about dart well the way
flutter is packaged by default is that
it includes the dart programming
language and its runtime so if the tools
required to run any dart code
it packages all of that in just one big
chunk for you so you don't have to go
and install different components like
install dart separately in flutter so
let's just then improvise and i'm going
to say
in here
let's say install flutter okay
then you go to this beautiful website
called flutter.dev
i'm going to increase the size here so
you see
so um
we go there now
and you will see this beautiful website
here
and what we're gonna do is just to press
on get started and remember
we press on get started but this
website looks like this right now maybe
in a few months or maybe in a few years
it will change so you'll just have to
find out a way to get to
the installation part right now it's
called get started and i can see it's
located as docs.flower dev get started
install
then pick your platform here i'm on a
macintosh but if you're on windows just
click on windows and then you get
instructions on how to install fodder
and then or if you're on linux you can
also do the same just get instructions
for your
platform
now i'm going to mac and i'm going to
click on mac and then
i'm going to
look at this information here i'm going
to increase the size so it's a little
bit easier to read and it says okay
download the following installation
bundle to get the latest stable release
of the flutter sdk
sdk means software development
development kit i believe so it's just
like series of tools for you to use it's
just fancy words so
then we're gonna do that let's just get
flutter mac
i'm gonna download it
and it may take some time because it is
actually quite a chunky
uh bit of software as you can see it's
almost 1.2 gigabytes
so depending on your internet connection
it could take
yeah anything between a few seconds to a
few minutes
after you've done that then you will
have to unzip that
in some folder
so
what that kind of means is just i can
see that my mac is already decompressing
this zip file for me so i don't have to
do that myself and it's already
decompressed in this place so i'm just
gonna click on it
and i'm gonna show you its content so it
kind of looks like this
okay
now that you have this what you need to
do is to ensure that all these files are
placed inside
a location on your computer
which is
protected so that you don't accidentally
delete it and it's also a good like um
you know exactly where it is so
by that i mean don't put it on a desk on
your desktop and don't put it in like
documents or anything it's not a
document software
what i like to do is usually to have a
folder
on a macintosh called dev so
i will open terminal here as you can see
terminal if you're not familiar with it
is an application that
you can
control pretty much the entire system
with it
if you're on a mac or if you're on linux
or any unix based system and if you're
on windows you can also do a lot with
your terminal
so in windows that terminal is called
cmd i believe
as in command i believe
on
linux and mac it's called terminal
i'm using a a terminal here called i
term
uh but if you're on vanilla mac os then
you would go and open terminal
like this which is just looking like
that
so i'm going to open i-term right now
which is my terminal you can open the
terminal that you're comfortable with
i'm going to increase the size of this
i like to place
my installations for these pieces of
software in my home directory which is
denoted by this little funny character
slash dev
and
if i look at the contents of this i can
see i have a folder called tooling if i
say tooling
and look at the contents of it i can see
flutter is right there
so
for me flutter installation you know
this folder that got in that got
downloaded for me in my downloads folder
i would go and copy its contents
contents and place it
in this folder so if i say cdflutter
and then you can see that i'm in my user
dev folder tooling flutter so this is
where i choose to put flutter now you
can choose to put this downloaded folder
anywhere else as the documentation tells
you
in the desired location for example
so
go ahead and do that pick a location and
for me this location works for you it
may be if you're on windows it would
probably be like c
backslash i don't know
you could say dev backslash tooling
backslash flutter this could be a good
location for your tooling hot photo
so
i'm imagining now that you've done that
you've gotten a folder and for me it's
this one where you've extracted your
flutter installation in
now you can see that it says
in this
third step you will need to expose
flutter's binary files to your system
and what that basically means is that
flutter as an sdk or a toolkit or a
framework
it has a lot of
bits and pieces of software in it and
some of these bits are more important in
that sense that they're actually
executable in that
imagine that um
on your computer
whether in macintosh windows or linux
you can have different documents some
documents can be text sound documents
can be images some documents can be i
don't know
what else they can be and or a word
document for instance okay because i
came up with another example
or they could be programs a program is
something that you can just double click
on and a piece of software gets executed
and then it will open for instance an
example of the program is a microsoft
word
another example of program is a google
chrome web browser
another example of program is safari
so these are programs and flutter comes
also with its own built-in programs that
do very specific and important things on
your computer
related to flutter of course
um
sorry i have to see my uh
recording studio nothing you had to do
uh it was just for me so
these important programs that are inside
the flutter installation which you just
downloaded need to be exposed to your
entire system
so that you can work with flutter
with with ease
and that means
if you're for instance from a design
background
it will allow you to anywhere in your
terminal just write figma and figma app
would open
and that's the same thing with flutter
in this folder you see we're in the
flutter folder where you downloaded your
installation and install it in this
folder there's a folder called bin which
means binary
in here there are so many things that
are important to the entire system to
run you see flutter and dart these two i
said so many but yeah there's pretty
much two
so these two binary uh executables need
to be exposed to your system
and the way to do that on a macintosh is
to change your paths as is documented
here
so the way i like to do that is i go and
change my
so if i do a vim and look at my zsh rc
i can see my paths and you can see it
here
so you see i've actually put that export
command as it is stated here
i put it here you see
this may be a bit intimidating to be
honest with you uh
what all it's doing is that you see this
file that i've
placed here i don't know if i can
actually zoom into it and if you can see
i don't know how that looked in the
actual recording
but
this is
a sort of like a set of instructions to
my terminal on this macintosh to tell it
where different
bits and pieces of
binary executables are placed such as
flutter
dart python etc etc so when i install a
piece of software
uh in this way you see we just
downloaded a package and just put it
somewhere on our computer uh macintosh
won't know about the stuff that's in it
of course it won't so you have to tell
it where those things are
because otherwise if you don't do this
step if you don't do the step three then
every time you want to run flutter then
you have to specify exactly where that
flutter command
is so for me it would be in my home
folder dev tooling flutter being slash
flutter
but if you do this then you can anywhere
in your terminal just write flutter and
your macintosh or linux or
windows computer will know where to find
it
so
do that put put these instructions as
specified here in your path
and after doing that you may need to
reload your path using a command
on windows and linux called
source
and the shrc for me
depending on which shell you have you
may have to
put that instruction in somewhere else
on windows i believe
you will have to modify your um
environment variables
i remember this from many many years ago
let's see if you have to do that
update your path you see
if you wish to run flutter commands in
regular windows console take these steps
blah blah from the start search end and
select edit environment variables for
accounts so
what you'll just have to do really is
just to follow these steps i mean i'm
going through basically giving you some
of the basics
of these instructions so you can get
like a head start but these instructions
can also change in the future so don't
rely just on what i'm telling you please
just go to the installation website here
uh here as you see docs flutter dev get
started install
and try to follow along with the
steps provided so
after you've done all of this
you should be able to be anywhere on
your computer
and just say flutter doctor
now fluffer doctor is a very important
command because
it looks at your flutter installation
and it kind of makes sure that it's in
good health as denoted by the word
doctor so
because fluttering itself is a framework
and it depends on many other bits and
pieces
which your computer may need to have in
order for flutter to actually work
optimally
um
flutter doctor will then go through a
series of steps to ensure that first
flutter is updated and that you for
instance have android
tool chain that you have xcode installed
chrome blah blah
so
i mean this result at the moment looks
quite fine on my computer but if you're
running flutter doctor for the first
time on your computer you may get a few
problems uh some of the problems that
you'll experience probably is going to
say android
sdk couldn't be found xcode couldn't be
found
because if you're running flutter on a
windows machine or linux machine then
you can't have xcode xcode is like the
software
provided by apple
and only runs unfortunately on mac os
and it's used for
compiling
or creating
mac os ios and ipad os pieces of
software so although you can run flutter
on your linux and on your
windows machine without a problem you
won't be able to produce or
test your flutter code running on an
iphone unfortunately unless you have
access to xcode
and the easiest way to get access to
that is of course to have a macintosh
and that's unfortunately because
unfortunate because yeah
it's uh it's just not available for
other platforms
so
you've run flutter doctor and it's
it's basically gonna tell you that okay
now i'm gonna assume that you're on a
macintosh it's gonna tell you that okay
uh xcode for instance uh you need to
install xcode and the way to do that is
you need to open app store on your
computer and just type xcode here
and go and install xcode on your
computer
um
so depending on i don't know which
version is the latest at the moment but
if you're trying to develop flutter
applications that and also make sure
that they run on your ios phone or the
ios simulator
then you need to install xcode if you're
on a mac sorry if you're on a linux
computer or windows you don't have to do
this step actually you can't do
unfortunately this thing
so once you've done that
you also need to make sure
that
you've installed develop developer tools
for xcode so let's see how we can do
that developer tools xcode
command line tools right
let's see
install
from terminal there's a command that you
can execute
in order to do that and that command
actually looks like this
here i'll
i will zoom into it so you can see
better
um
it says sudo xcode select install
so you need to issue that command in
your terminal so if i do that and it
says what's the password i'll enter my
password
and it says they're already installed so
if you haven't done that please go ahead
and execute this command in order to
install command line tools for your
xcode
now the next piece after xcode that you
will need is
let's see if i can actually bring up
so we've talked about flutter doctor
that was flutter doctor and we also
talked about installing xcode so i'm now
bringing that up a little bit late
and but now the next step is to install
android studio
so
what android studio is is like the
equivalent of xcode but for writing
android specific applications now
for in order to write flutter
applications you don't need android
studio per se but you kind of need the
sdk manager
now
both ios and android
um
for programmers they provide you with
something called an sdk just like
flutter is an sdk or tool kit
ios and android also provide you with
sdk in order to write native
applications
and since flutter utilizes these native
capabilities of each platform in order
to for instance create an application
that's compatible with ios or android
it will utilize the native uh components
or sorry or the native pieces of
software namely called
xcode
sorry mainly called ios sdk and android
sdk
so you need to download android studio
so you get access to the sdk manager so
you can install an android sdk
now xcode in itself when you download
the latest version of xcode it comes
with the latest version of the ios sdk
but android studio doesn't do that
wait a minute yeah it probably does in
the latest versions but we can check
that out
so if you go to your browser and just
say android studio
and then you open up
developerandroid.com let's just go there
and then you can just click on download
android studio and then there are
download options and you can see there's
available for windows mac and linux
so
then please go ahead and download uh
your android studio and i can see the
for macintosh is a package so you can
install it easily you don't have to
unzip anything and for windows is also
like an executable so tar gz
as well for linux so
now let's say that you've done that and
now after doing that then you should be
able to bring up
android studio
let's see
i'll bring it up here
now
when you bring up your android studio it
will just pretty much be empty here
on the screen and you'll get some tips
and tricks how to use android studio but
the important thing for you here is to
be able to install uh
the android sdk so if you go then to
tools
i believe there is an sdk manager right
here
so just ensure that you have
an sdk installed for me i have android
installed here so ensure that you have
one of these sdks ready for you to use
by flutter
and as soon as you've done that then
when you run then your um
clutter doctor
command
and
the part about android sdk is going to
be
ticked here
uh sorry the android studio
so that's that so we've talked about
android tool chain which is the android
sdk you can see
we've talked about xcode chrome is just
a web browser if you want you can have
that if you're developing app flutter
applications for the web it kind of is
necessary
um
and then this you're probably if you're
just getting started with flutter you're
not going to have this vs code part
ticked because vs code is
a a code editor an open source code
editor provided by
microsoft
and it is the code editor that i'm going
to use for the entire course for this
entire course as we go on and to be
honest with you i've tried android
studio and i've tried vs code for
flutter development and i can highly
recommend that you use vs code
just for its sheer performance it's for
its simplicity
extensions and
its ability just to really focus on a
simple editor without bothering you with
lots of bells and whistles so
it's a preference though some people use
android studio for flutter development
and some people use vs code so
i don't think
one is better than the other it's
completely a preference so
so that's for android studio and the
android sdk so now let's go ahead and
install visual studio code which is the
tool that i'm going to use for this
course so
let's bring up a new window and i'm
going to say install visual studio code
and i'm going to bring the window up
here so you see
let's go here and
and you can download the one that you
prefer for your computer i've chosen mac
and for me specifically i have a
macintosh with an apple silicon so
i then choose this one mac with an apple
silicon and then it's gonna download
that for you automatically so it's just
about 200 megabytes i think or actually
100 megabyte only after you've done that
just
on a macintosh you would go and
put that on uh
in your applications folder so i'm
actually gonna delete that which i
downloaded just now because i already
have vs code
on my system
so that's for visual studio code um
so let's go ahead now and
now that we've done that
i'm gonna
talk a little about
talk a little bit about um some
extensions that we're gonna use in
visual studio code so let me bring up my
terminal
and um
you know we don't need that let's go and
bring up visual studio code um and then
i already actually have so many visual
studio code windows open
uh but i can just say new window so you
see how visual studio code looks like
and then
let's see don't show again okay so this
is pretty much how visual studio code
looks like so it's a very simple
application to begin with
um now what we need to do for this
example is to enable a few extensions
now the first section extension that
we're going to enable is called arrow
lens and you need to go here on the left
hand side find extensions and just type
error um if i can type air
and just say airlance just like that
click on airlands and just press enable
or install i believe it's called so
error lens allows you to see errors in
line without you having to click on a
specific line of
error basically so
it expands the entire error as you're
coding you will probably have some
errors in your code that error will be
then displayed right there in front of
your face in its entirety so you don't
have to press a little small button to
be able to see the complete air
so it's a fantastic extension
to be honest with you
now the other thing that you'll need is
something called a bracket pair
colorizer and that bracket pair
colorizer is something that is already
installed in visual studio code
it used to be a an extension that you
could download but it was so popular
that microsoft has added that internally
to visual studio code so you don't have
to do that manually sorry by installing
an extension so
now that we've talked about that the
next step is to actually install flutter
and dart
extensions so here just type
flutter
do that and then just
click on the install
button i've already installed that so
there's a disable button for me here
the flutter
extension and then you'll also need the
dart extension so just type dart and
then install that as well
so after these two
installations
we also need to install another
great extension called block bloc
i'm not going to go into the details of
what block is because we will learn
about block a lot later in the course
but it is just a great
extension to have as we go on you're
going to learn about it so
i can't really explain exactly what it
is right now but just install it and i
will tell you more about block later in
the course i promise
so
that was basically installing a block
now
when you start up your visual studio
code it probably doesn't look like the
way it does for me
and that is because i have a custom
theme installed on my visual studio code
called tokyo night
it is a very very mellow dark
theme as it's called
and scenes in visual studio code can be
installed just like you install an
extension so if you like my theme you're
more than welcome to go in into
extensions and then search for tokyo
night
and just install it
so that's
it has different theme colors as well
this is the one i use tokyo knight
actually i use this one tokyo night
so if you want that theme please go
ahead and
install it
and now that we've talked about that we
come to
the last point that i wanted to discuss
basically
in uh before we wrap up this chapter
which is our chapter two so
now that we talked about a little bit of
setup for setting up your flutter
installation and setting up your text
editor which in this case is visual
studio code
in the next chapter which is chapter 3
we're going to talk about
dart programming so before we actually
jump into writing flutter applications
we're going to talk about how to write
code in uh
dart
or at least understand like the basics
of dart
so without further ado let's close up
this chapter and i'll see you in the
next one
hello everyone and welcome to the third
chapter of our flutter course
in this chapter i thought maybe we could
focus a little bit on um actually not a
little bit but quite a lot on dart
as you know from the previous chapter we
know now that dart is the programming
language that
powers
uh flutter
so
it would be a good idea for us at least
to get a little bit of introduction to
dart how it works a little bit of its
internals
different data types functions methods
classes and
this chapter as well um just like the
entire course i'm kind of assuming that
you haven't done any programming at all
before so i'm going to take things
very slowly uh take the concepts one at
a time introduce them to you
so
and i will give you some references to
read more about the topics as
we won't have really
that much of a time in this course to go
into detail about everything so
um
the goal of this chapter is to
basically get you started with
programming uh
dart uh and writing your apps then later
for flutter
in order to do that we need to have a
project
set up
and by project i mean you need to have
some kind of a playground set up so that
you can start writing
dart code and then you can try it on for
instance a telephone or a simulator or
what have you
now
um a lot of people would rather go to
dark pad as we saw in the previous
chapter and start writing their code in
dart pad
that's one way of doing it but since in
this chap in this pro in this course
we're gonna
write
an application release it for ios on
android
um it is safe to say that that
we can literally start actually creating
our real project here and now
so that we can then later build upon it
rather than writing all our code in dart
pad
because
you can then by doing by writing your
code in an actual flutter project you
can get used to how we work with
flutter as a whole
so i think this is a little bit of a
time invested into later chapters as
well where we're gonna work and continue
working on the same project so we have
to just set it up once
but at the same time
there is a little bit of a value in not
blending in too much of our
test code like what we're doing in this
chapter with what we're going to do
later
in the actual application if you know
what i mean so
so i think it would be better now for us
to set up just a test application
and then
keep working on it and then later on
when we start doing the actual
application then we create a separate
project for that so
now
let's then
do that together so i'm gonna bring
my face down here so you see the entire
entire screen
i'm then going to create a new terminal
window and bring it up here on the
screen so you can see it and i'm going
to increase the font so it's a little
bit easier to spot what i'm typing
so let's go to a folder where you try to
or where you
keep your
uh projects for me i go to dev projects
and i have a folder there called flutter
so i try to put all my
flutter projects in here
then in order to create a new flutter
project
what you have to do is to issue the
flutter
create command
and this create command is already
shipped inside flutter so if you say
which flutter
this is going to go and find the actual
flatter binary if you remember from the
previous chapters where we installed
flutter
it's going to find the flutter binary
and then
call the create command on it so if you
say flocker create
it expects you to kind of like
provide it with some sort of a name of a
project so let's just say
learning guard
learning er mean dart
so
that's the binary that's the command and
that is the name of the project okay so
uh this is the easiest way to create a
new floater flutter project in my
opinion at least so let's execute that
command
it's gonna do its thing
and what i'm gonna do then is to as you
can see it's created a new
folder called learning dart
so let's go and i'm going to say
cd learning dart
and then i'm going to issue a command
called code dot and
i can actually bring this a little bit
to the right so you can and also
do like this so you can see what i'm
typing
as you can see i've written
code dot and what code does is that it
brings up visual studio code so it's
just like a
command that you can issue in order to
bring a visual studio code and
um
if if i just bring up visual studio code
the way it is right now
and for instance you can see it you
can't see it right now but it's because
i have a separate uh screen here i'll
bring up visual studio code as you can
see here by hand
there is a good extension where there is
an ability
for visual studio code to install this
code
shortcut for you in terminal in your
path so if you say which code
it just says user local bin code
so it's just an executable that allows
you then to open up visual studio code
with a path like so you can say open a
visual studio code in this folder
so you can just say code
dot so
and you can do that in visual studio
code you can allow that to be installed
by doing um command shift p on macintosh
or control shift p i i believe in
windows
and
linux
and there is this little command here
that says shell command install code
command in path so if you execute that
once then it's already set up for you
you don't have to do that anymore so if
you'd like to be able to say code
dot in terminal
and open the current folder
within visual studio code without you
having to open visual studio code
manually and then doing file open
then i suggest that you do command shift
p or control shift p
in visual studio code depending on which
operating system you're using and then
choosing shell command install code
command in path so i've already done
that so i can just say code dot
and i'll bring this up here
so as you can see this is the basics of
a simple
um flutter project that you create with
flutter create now visual studio code
has a built-in terminal so i don't have
to have this terminal window open
anymore so i'm just gonna close it okay
and i'm gonna make this full screen
increase the size a little bit so you
can see better and perhaps i could even
remove this flutter
logo on top right so you can see the
content a little bit better as well
so that's the creation
of our
simple flutter project now
in order for this flutter project to run
and you be able to run this
application and like keep testing your
project
you would have to select a target and
you do that with command shift p
and then
choosing flutter select device so you
can just say flutter select device
enter
command shift p is on macintosh and ctrl
shift p i believe is in linux and
windows so do that command shift b is a
very important command you're going to
use it quite a lot in this course so
just learn that please
um then i'm going to say select device
and i'm going to choose
since i'm on a macintosh and as you saw
earlier we have xcode already installed
xcode comes also with the entire ios sdk
and also with the simulator i can choose
to run our application on ios simulator
or i can choose to run it on an actual
phone
now for
this
um
i believe i don't know if you've talked
already about scrcpy to be honest with
you i'm just gonna
search in my notes um to see if you've
talked about that and
if you just give me one second i'll just
check here i believe we're we're gonna
set it up in chapter six so we haven't
set up scrcp cpy yet so for that purpose
i'm just going to say select device and
i'm just going to say start ios
simulator so that is going to as you can
see start up by your simulator and that
for now is like the best way for us to
test our application so
while this is connecting um i can show
you a little bit around as well
we have as you can see lots of files
here already created for us we're going
to go through some of these um
but one of the most important files that
you're going to need to get used to used
to is this lib slash main.dart and this
is where like the majority of the code
is written so
uh this is his contents at the moment um
let's see what it's doing with the
simulator i'm just gonna have a look
here
um
it's taking a little bit longer than
expected so what i'm gonna do is i'm
just gonna
kill the io simulator manually this
shouldn't this usually doesn't happen
but that's okay if it does happen then
you know how to deal with it just close
the simulator
um and then i'm just gonna
go to command shift p select device and
then start ios simulator fresh so it's
starting right now
okay so that's our simulator and i'm
actually going to decrease the size of
this a little bit since i realize that
it is a
very large font so
this is our main dart file this is like
where the flutter
command line um command has created
it is the file that has been created for
us so we don't have to play around with
it too much to be honest with you at the
moment
um for the purpose of this chapter we're
just gonna have a look at um
basically kind of like exploiting this
uh code so that we can inject our code
into it so we can learn dart a little
bit so you don't have to understand all
of this code the way it is right now
there's lots of comments and etc so
so that's
that part so now that we're here and
then you can see we have a little
simulator here and in order to run this
application on this simulator since
you've already done the flutter select
command
you just go to run and you say run
without debugging for now so
since the simulator
is already selected then it understands
that it needs to compile this project
for my simulator so
um
and we're just going to give it some
time depending on your machine and like
what you have for specifications on your
machine this this command could take
anywhere between
a couple seconds to maybe 30 seconds
or even more and i'm not sure how long
it's going to take for a fresh flutter
project to be honest with you to start
running on the simulator but it took
about 21 seconds so or 22 seconds so
um
i will bring up the
project now and this is like the basic
flutter project i'm not going to go into
details about how it works but you can
press the plus button if you want to so
but what i'm going to do i'm just going
to close this widget inspector that was
opened
automatically and i'm just going to
bring this a little bit down so that we
can see the debug console okay
so
that's for setting up our project so
that part is done now the first thing
that we need to talk about
when we start talking about
dart is the concept of keywords
now since i'm assuming that you haven't
done any programming language in any
other place before
um
you need to understand what keywords are
they're very
important in understanding any
programming language basically and
keywords are
um
[Music]
concisely explained there are
words that are reserved
for
the programming language
that you
cannot use for anything else than what
the programming language intends those
words to be used as
i know that sounds a little bit
difficult but
i mean there's no real good analogy in
like if you're coming from figma if
you're coming from a design world what a
key word could be because in a design
world you're not really talking
in terms of code with your product or
with your
software where you're designing your
stuff but
when you come to programming language as
you know it's a language so
words mean stuff in in a programming
language so a keyword is as its name
indicates is a word that has a special
meaning in that particular particular
language and
i provide a link here for you that you
can check out but i'm going to open it
up and
bring it to the screen here increase the
size a little bit so we can see better
uh have a look at my screen here yeah
and you can see this is a part of the
documentation for dark programming
language that explains what keywords are
in dart and you can see there are some
words that have special meaning like
show import
extends async await break
so you can say that the language the
dark language is made out of these
keywords that is pretty much it it's
just like series of keywords like the
things that you tell the language that
hey i want to do something and then it
says okay what do you want to do then
you say okay i want to do this or this
or this so
special words for the programming
language so that it understands what you
mean basically
so that's for keywords um
for now we don't have to really go into
so much more details about what a
keyword is but for now just understand
that a keyword is a special word
in the programming language
language's brain kind of so that you can
talk to it it's your interface with the
programming language to make it
understand what you want to do okay
and please check out the link that i
provided here to understand more about
keywords
okay so we've talked about keywords i'm
just gonna check it in my notes so that
we know we've talked about it
now the next concept that we need to
talk about are
data types
um
if you for instance come from a design
background then you have different tools
to work with for instance you may have
in your design system whatever you're
using if you're using product from adobe
or if you're using for instance figma or
whatever
visio or whatever tool you're using then
there's like a set of components that
you can work with for instance you can
drag in a text field or you can drag in
an image field or sorry an image or you
can for instance assign
assign a color to a text so these are
all like things that you can do with
that
software
now a data type in in a programming
language like dart
is that type of a thing for instance you
would say
i have some data in my mind okay what is
it it's the first name of a
of my friend okay his name is uh
jack or whatever um
and then you would say okay what type is
jack is it a number no is it like um
is it a list of things well yeah it's a
list of uh characters yeah
uh okay then it's that is this data type
or you could say
i'm thinking about my age
my age is let's say i'm 37.
okay what is 37 is it a list of things
well yeah it kind of is a list of
numbers
list of digits but it's also in itself a
number so
then there has been this convention like
convention in different programming
languages and every program language
language pretty much that you can use
these days has this concept of data
types data type is as its name indicates
a
a specific
specific name assigned to
to a series
a specific name assigned to a data
that is bound to be of a specific type
as well so for instance in dart you have
data types called integers or you have
strings or you have arrays and sets
which we'll talk about soon but
a data type just for now though it's
just a stamp on a piece of data to say
that you're of this specific type
so
you could think of a data data type as a
nationality you could say like every
person coming from sweden is swedish
boom that's his data type so it's just a
categorization of data based on their
appearance or based on what they
actually hold so
for instance you can say here's a
university full of engineers and
these are software engineers these are
mechanical engineers so the software
engineer is a data type it or is a
person type a category type so putting
stamps on things based on the
categorization is kind of what data type
does and
in short i mean
you just have to know that it's just a
categorization of things based on
what they hold so
and there's and there's a website that
you can read about uh dart data types
and it's right here
i don't know if you've i've if i've
provided it here
on the link below as you can see dart
core library html so
um and here you can read more about dart
data types
but we're not going to go into so much
detail about all these right now just
know that
data type in dart is or any programming
language basically that has data types
is a categorization of
data based on their appearance or
contents
now
let's talk a little about
something called constants in dart
a constant
usually in programming language
languages are
values
whose value cannot be changed
that's a little bit meta but
uh let's say for instance the value of
um
a value of 10
it's a number
it cannot be changed 10 is 10 and it
will always be 10.
um
or your name that is a constant although
you can go and change it but as long as
that is your name it is a constant so
um
another example of a i mean
there are so many values that can be
constants which will actually be quite
abstract for me to be able to explain
right now but just know that a constant
is a value whose
internal data cannot change during
the
during where you're writing your program
and also during when you're running your
program so
um that is kind of what a constant is
uh but there is also this uh notion of a
compile time constant and a runtime
constant and i i mean
you don't have to know about
uh
like those different types of constants
right now just because like in dart a
constant is a constant whether it's
runtime or
compile time is constant it's just just
a constant as you'll see soon but
i still believe that it's important to
understand the difference between
compile time and runtime
when you're talking about programming
and when you're becoming software
developer and i hope by the end of this
course you'll actually become a software
developer if you're not already um that
would be really amazing uh but
the notion of a compile time and a and
runtime is very important to understand
and
developers like to um
make a distinction between whether
something has happened during compile
time or something has happened during
runtime and
compile time is
or before i explain compile time maybe i
should explain compile compile is where
you take the program that you're writing
here
and you tell the computer that i want
you to package this up
so that i can run it later on
x and y machine
so that process of packaging things up
simply said is
in very simple terms it's called
compiling or a compilation okay so
um
from where you start writing your
program with the hand with your fingers
until where you package it you're pretty
much just compiling it okay
but when you run it like we're running
it at the moment on
ios simulator
that session from where you start
outputting your program into this device
and for it to run your program from that
moment on
then
the distinction separates into
runtime
so
you haven't compiled time and runtime
and a constant is a value that is the
same during compile time and runtime so
its value doesn't change so the value of
10 is 10 while you're writing your
program and also stays the value of 10
while the program is
running so
that is a
very simple explanation of a constant so
now let's
put
constants and data types uh
in practice now in this
project that was created for you by
flutter create
in this in this line of code as you can
see it says void main we're not going to
talk about exactly what that is but just
press enter at the end of it and just
write
final
and i'm going to tell you what final is
soon
and just saying name is equal to foo
okay
this is
there's lots going on in here and i'm
gonna tell you um
what is actually happening here
um
but i before before we actually go
through all these details let's let's
add something here called a constant so
i'm just kind of saying const age is 27
or yeah 27. as you can see this is how
you write code in dart you start by a
keyword usually or a variable name or
something as we're going to talk about
it
but const is a keyword okay
and it tells dart that what
is following here is a name right after
cons i'm going to write some name
and in that name then i'm going to
basically say okay i'm adding the value
of 27 to this
h i'm sorry about this my dog also
barking a little bit
so
what is happening here is that you're
telling dart that i'm
putting the value of 27 into a constant
call h
and you can refer to this age later for
instance you can say
then
const age
twice the age
you can say is equal to age multiplied
by two and this is also constant because
at compile time word dart is basically
trying to understand what you've written
it says okay you said 27 and then you're
saying 27 is a constant so its value is
never going to change and if you tell me
multiplied by 2 that also is a constant
because
both this side and this side are compile
time constants
so that's that's what we mean by a
constant it's a value that is specified
during compile time and it and it cannot
change so
also it's important to know that notice
that your learning guard and
here is
sorry i have to just take some items in
my notes to make sure that i've
explained all of those to you um
you can see here that every line of code
in dart needs to end with a semicolon
and that tells dart that yeah you're
starting a new line of code of course
you can put two lines of code like this
but if you just press save
there is a program automatically running
in the background which is called dart
fmt which is the dart formatter which is
going to format your code and prefix it
so if i like put a lot of spaces in here
and just press save
you can see upon
doing command s on mac or control s on
linux and windows upon saving dart
formatter is gonna kick in and format
the code for you so
just a little hint
um
okay
those are constants so we've talked
about that
now let's talk about variables a little
bit
a variable is
usually
anything that contains
a value that is not a constant
i mean i think that's like the
simplest way of explaining what a
variable is um a variable as a name
indicates it can vary
and that means that the data that it
holds it doesn't need to be constantly
the same it means that
from where you start the program you may
actually
assign a value to this variable and you
may also change that variable depending
on what type of variable it is
um
so
there's also
this notion of
a final variable in dart which we'll
talk about soon so
before we do that let's go to this main
function here and you could just say um
var name is fu
and here what i've done is that i've
created a variable
indicated by the var keyword
whose value is foo or let's just say
alex
and semicolon to end the line now if i
want to change this value all i could
say here is to say name is equal to
anthony
or whatever
now this is basically us assigning a new
value to this variable saying anthony
um
as i said there is also a
no the notion in
dart
for a keyword called
final
so you could just say final name equal
to alex and it's it's a little bit
strange because final is also a variable
whose value cannot be changed so you may
be like okay what like what kind of a
variable is that like
how is that not a constant
now there's a little limitation because
you you may try to like say const
aim alex
but this
as you will see later in in the
in the course
final gives you the flexibility to
assign a value to your variable
a little bit later maybe in the process
of creating it
but it still indicates to dart that the
value of this variable is not gonna
change after it has been assigned to
it's a little bit
yeah it's it's it's just a little bit
confusing maybe at the moment so let's
just say
a variable is like a constant but its
value can be changed let's just leave it
at that okay so
uh
that's it
okay now that we talked a little bit
about a little bit about uh
variables let's talk about functions so
um i didn't specify exactly what this is
just because we hadn't really come to
functions
but a function is
a body
of code is a grouping of series of lines
of code one to n number of n lines of
codes
that
is logically
uh grouped
and it can it has a few properties uh
one is its return value here indicated
by void
the other part of its information is its
name
followed by a pair of parentheses
an open parenthesis and a closed
parenthesis
in which you will write something called
the function arguments
or parameters
um
it's pretty much just like uh
imagine like
a box where you input things in it it
does some processing and then it outputs
that stuff whatever it wants to output
so
what we could do here is to create a
very simple function for for ourselves
by
as you see as you saw before or as i
mentioned before
what you write for a function in the
beginning is this data type i mean what
data comes out of this function
and
um
and here
let's say we want to add
someone's first name and their last name
with a space between it so if i say foo
as the first name and bar as the last
name then the full name should be fu bar
and with the space in between
so
as i said then you need to specify the
data type first what you're gonna return
and if you looked at the documentation
that i provided earlier there's a data
type called string
which is a series of characters
basically it could be a name a family
name address of your house or whatever
and that's a data type is string okay so
we say we're outputting string and then
you say okay what should this function
be called
um
there's a convention in dart that your
functions should follow a camel case
naming convention basically in camel
cases if you for instance say
in english my function should be called
get full name
that's my function name but you cannot
have spaces in your function function
names in dart or pretty much every
programming language that i know about
then
remove all the spaces and then except
for the first word
change all because uh cons all the other
words
uh first letter to uh to uppercase so
it was like this before you could
actually change them to uppercase first
and then remove the spacing so this is
this is how you should write your
function names
this is called camel case
full name okay
we said that we also have to open
parenthesis
now
let's just say then
we need to uh specify somehow that we're
going to accept a first name and a last
name
well
what kind of a data type does a first
name have well
it's kind of like a string it's a name
it's a series of characters so let's
just type string here
and then we want to take a first name
and we know about camel case now so
let's just say first name
is uppercase and remove the
spacing so
first name
hey that's the parameter
and then you want to go to the next
parameter so just say comma
and then you want to say
string last name
you take the first name and the last
name
now we also said that after the
parenthesis after you have accepted your
parameters you want to go and create
like your curly brackets here i don't
know actually if i mentioned that before
but every function is either
its body or its logic it's either
followed by equal
greater than sign which we're going to
talk about later or
sco uh
is by curly bracket so we're just going
to use curly brackets
now there
what you want to do here you want to
take the first name and add a space to
the first name and then follow that by
the last name so
you need to you you need to tell dart
that that is the data you want to return
and
thankfully there is a
um
there's a keyword called return that
tells dart that you want to return some
value from a function so
then what you're going to do you're
going to say i want to return what the
first name and i want to add a space
single quotes space
us
last name
right
so
i mean
this is a very simple implementation of
get full name so um
however there's there's actually a
better way of doing this in dart and
i'll explain it to you right now and
that is by formatting your strings
so
let's say that you want to
basically
tell dart kind of like how your result
looks like and you want to ask dart to
insert the first name and last name into
that result for you
and that's how you'll do it like this
you say
okay i want to return a string denoted
by the single quotation marks here and
you can also do a string in dart with
double quotation marks but i'm going to
explain that a little bit later
so let's say that you
want to
return the first name in here but if you
say first name
what's going to happen here is that it's
actually going to take this first name
as
has you written in the string so when
you get this return value it's actually
going to say first name
not the value that you pass to this i
know it may be a little bit
difficult to understand when i say the
value that you pass to this what does it
even mean
uh so let's put this actually to test
first okay
go now into
this
build function as you can see here on
line 16. now it may not be on line 16
for you but for me is at the moment on
line 16. just find this class my app
stateful stateless widget and find this
widget build stuff that's written there
create a new line here
okay
and just say
full name
or sorry say print
as i'm writing it here
print
and then just say
what do we call our function get full
name
see here
and it says okay what's the first name
i'll say quotation marks who
and the last name is bar
and ended with a
semicolon so and ignore this call for
now sorry this uh warning avoid print
calls and production codes so
okay so
now we're calling that function this is
the
it's i mean it's called calling it's
called invoking
it may have other names but usually
programmers call this calling call the
function
and
these are the parameters that you're
passing to this function okay
so uh
the
i mean there are two words
used for
in in the programming world to explain
these parameters like with with name and
that is called a parameter or an
argument i mean they're used
interchangeably
the meaning of them is kind of like
getting uh convoluted in to the point
that no one knows which one is which but
you could just use parameter or argument
and everybody would understand what
you're saying so but there's a little
bit of the difference which i'm not
going to go into the detail of but if
someone just says call this function
with parameters or arguments you know at
least what you're doing okay
foo bar
now we're printing its value all you
have to do in order to execute this code
is press command s and you will see the
result
outputted here now
what we did here
um
what we did here was very
very key
feature in flutter called
hot reload
as you saw i didn't execute my code
again i didn't press like the run button
again i just said save
now saving in flutter
triggers an action called hot reload
hot reload in flutter is it's a whole
topic of its own
which i'm not gonna go so much into
detail of but what hot reload does
really is
it looks for changes
in
in your code hierarchy without
complicating it too much i'm just trying
to phrase my
sentence
right so that it's um
not too complicated for
this chapter
it looks for changes that you made to
the code and executes only those changes
okay
and in the process of executing those
changes it might execute everything else
that is in its uh
in its path and
by doing a save this function gets
called somehow magically which i'm not
going to go into
right now
which in turn then calls or invokes our
function called getfullname and
its value will then be passed into
another function called print
okay
i hope that that made sense
uh and as you can see the result isn't
really what we expected it just says
first name
and that is because here we said return
first name and as you can see if you put
first name like this inside your string
it becomes its own string it has nothing
to do with this
anymore
if you remove these quotation marks
however
then it says oh first name is this
parameter
you see it actually highlights it so
then if i press command s on mac or
control s on linux and windows you will
see
foo being printed to the screen
okay
you can also say last name here and it
will say bar
right
and know that no also notice that when
i'm changing these things it's not
executing immediately automatically i'm
pressing command s so just keep that in
mind please so
so
that's for a function and but before we
move on explaining the basics of a
function i want to also explain
a little bit about
string formatting and that is we said
that we're going to put first name and
last name because this is what we did in
the beginning first name plus space plus
last name and this wasn't so pretty
because it's like doing string
concatenation in a very old-fashioned
matter in a very old-fashioned manner
yeah i think i said it right the first
time
but what you want to do here is to
uh use uh garth's built-in formatting
capabilities and you do that by first
saying that okay i want to return some
sort of a string
and i want to have first name
space
last name but as you saw this earlier if
i command s or control s
it just returns those strings exactly as
i've written them not the parameters
what you can do is just to put a dollar
before them
and you can see their coloring now
changes depending on the theme that
you're using or depending on the text
editor that you're using if you're using
android studio it may not color it the
same way or if you're using visual
studio with a different theme on a
different maybe platform you may not
even change the color but for me at
least you can see that the change the
colors change so as to indicate that now
i'm not actually returning
the string exactly as you wrote
except on returning the parameters
that are here
so command this
and now you can see that the result is
full bar
okay
so that is the basics of functions in
in dart
before we move on
from functions i also want to explain
quickly that
um a function doesn't necessarily have
to return anything
and that means that
you may have a function here that wants
to just print some data to
uh the screen or to here to the debug
console and you can just call it
print my name
and parenthesis and
curly brackets and
as you can see here
i can just write the name of the
function without any
data type to be returned but it's a
little bit of a convention that you
actually tell dark that this is a void
function
meaning void is a key word as we talked
about it earlier in the beginning of
this
chapter
void is a key word telling dark that
this is a function that doesn't return
anything and as you can see
dart is completely fine with this
function being completely empty meaning
that well yeah you said you're not
returning anything you're probably just
gonna do some stuff in here so i'm not
gonna bother you with some errors saying
oh you forgot to do something
but as soon as you change the return
value or the return data type of your
function to for instance string
then you'll get an error
saying that oh yeah the body might
complete normally causing null to be
returned blah blah you don't have to
know exactly what that means but
essentially what that means is you're
telling dart that you're returning a
string but you're not returning anything
it's literally
looking for the return keyword
saying that oh you missed it so you
could silence that uh error by saying
return an empty string
semicolon
so
i think this pretty much explains the
basics of um
functions to be honest with you
there's lots more to learn about
functions and as i said functions can
also be like
written
using this syntax and
this syntax is used when your function
is very simple or in that
it doesn't need to break into different
lines of code
by a semi-colon so a function who has a
very simple logic you can just skip
writing
these square brackets
no curly brackets sorry
and you can just say you see i will
remove this
put equal sign
greater than sign
remove the closing curly bracket
and then you can remove the return
statement and that's it
that is a shorthand it's a function
shorthand in dart
and you could use it simply to
simplify kind of your code some people
may like it some people kind of may be
against it
just because it's um
it kind of splits your
code into two different styles some
functions are with uh curly brackets
some functions are with this pointer
thingy and uh kind of depends on your
and you on you and your team to be
honest
um
i know usually from my um
from my experience usually
we software developers like to follow
conventions so in one
in one project
the developers may decide okay we're
just going to go with this convention
and since
using curly brackets
involves the ability to have both
complicated and simple return statements
in a function it's actually preferred
as a convention than using this syntax
simply because this syntax doesn't allow
you to split your code into separate
lines of code it has to all be in one
statement so if that makes any sense
so i think i think that's it for
functions and now we've talked about
functions arguments return values
we talked about variables constants
data types and
keywords in dart and
these are such important parts of
learning how to program with dark and
flutter that i think you need to spend
some time and experiment with them so do
some experimentations on your own for
instance take
not don't take just the first name and
last name just take for instance
someone's address someone's age
different play around a little bit with
different data types like integers
different numbers have a look at the
link that i provided
earlier which was here i'll bring it up
again so you can see that
have a look at this link and have a look
at the different examples of different
data types because in this in
in the
upcoming chapters and in the uh rest of
this course we're going to play around
with a lot of different types of data
types
so i think it's important that you have
a look a little bit
at the documentation as well
so
let's leave this chapter at this point
and then in the next chapter we're going
to talk a lot more about more advanced
dart programming language features so
thank you for joining me for this
chapter and see you in the next one
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 4
of this flutter course
in the previous chapter chapter 3 we
talked about keywords data types
constants variables and some basics of
functions
and in this chapter we are going to
as you can see on the captions here
we're going to focus on control
statements and
collections now
um i'm assuming you're following these
chapters
um chronologically so that you're like
going
one by one so i'm assuming then that you
have your uh dark project set up and
that you've got some sort of a simulator
or emulator running
so
without further ado let's have a look at
um i'm actually gonna
bring up the captions here and then i'm
gonna put my face at the bottom there
and bring up our project that we created
in the previous chapter
up here so this this is running at the
moment so if i do a command s or control
s on linux and windows
then as you can see here there is a run
button
and then
it's just gonna do a hot reload which in
turn calls this build function which we
don't yet know really how it works
because i haven't really explained it
but
what we did we just
called a print function here and then
our get full name function so
what i'm going to do here is let's
remove this code from the build
and let's remove everything that we
wrote here as well so keep the main
function as you can see here and then
keep your stateless widget which we're
going to talk about later okay
so instead go and create a new function
that is called void
test
all right
and then in the build function just say
test
all right
just like that
the purpose is that in this function
we're going to write most of the code in
this chapter so we are going to
basically test some code that's the
purpose of this function so
let's talk about if and else if and l's
are
control statements in
most programming languages that allow
you to
branch your code based on a condition
so if we for instance in here create a
final
variable whose value cannot be changed
if you remember from the previous
chapter whose value cannot be changed
after it's been assigned to
let's say final name is foo
all right
and end it with the same semicolon
now
an if statement basically allows you to
check the value or a condition
to be
of a certain
value or to be true or false
and
then it allows you to execute some code
and then you can also
append an else statement to it which
gets executed if the code or if that
condition is not met i'm going to show
you how that is written
the syntax for an if statement is just
if
and if is an is a keyword
so you would say if
and then you would open and close
parenthesis and then you would put curly
brackets like this that's the syntax of
if and in the parenthesis you would put
your condition
so i would say in this case if name and
i would like to for instance check if
name is foo
now
uh we haven't come to operators yet
we're going to talk about operators
actually soon
but this is um as you can see here we're
saying final name equal to foo this is
kind of like um
an assignment uh operation and that is
an operator in dart it's called an
operator
so
there is also
and since this is an assignment we don't
want to actually assign anything to name
you want to check if it's of a certain
value and
that is with this conditional operator
equal equal
and then you will just say okay if it's
foo then for instance print
uh yes
this is foo
and then a semi colon to end it however
if this condition is not met you may
want to execute another piece of code
and then you can just do else
like that
and then this would you would just say
no this is not foo
all right and a semicolon so i'm just
going to do command s and you can see
the value or the string yes this is food
printed to the screen or to the terminal
here or to the debug console
you can have multiple statements in here
so you can have more print statements in
here you can just do anything you want
basically in here
and the same goes for else
now there is a possibility to write if
statements kind of without
the curly brackets but you don't see
them that often and i recommend that you
actually always try to as a convention
do with curly brackets if you can
however it is possible that inside a
code base that you will work on with
your colleagues it is decided that it's
okay to have if statements without curly
brackets where there are very simple and
one-liners basically
so let me show you
an example of that you could just say if
name is foo
you would just say print yes this is foo
and this is completely accepted as well
so because it's a one-liner
but if you then say
okay i want to have another line print
hello world
you can see it goes to the next line
meaning that
this line right here
will be executed no matter your
condition up there so this is completely
detached from your if statement up here
okay
and i just realized that it is quite
important for me to be able to show line
numbers
and by default your editor probably has
line numbers enabled i usually disable
line numbers
when i'm working myself basically
but when talking about code with other
people it's quite useful to have line
numbers because i can then tell you oh
look at line nine or look at my line ten
okay so
that's the basic of if and else
now you can also have if right after
else so
an example of that is for instance to
say if name is fu
and then you do some code all right
you say print yes it is foo
not food
after the curly bracket then you would
say else
and then you can then say another if
else if
all right
and then after if comes the
parenthesis and a curly bracket if you
remember from the if before
it is the exact same syntax as it as it
is here
so there's pretty much no difference you
can you see if
and then if
and then you put your condition in here
you would just say if name
and then you may just want to say is not
and that's another operator
it's uh basically is a not operator so
it's checking to make sure that this
name is not
of the value that you provide to the
right hand side
and then you can say bar
and print
this value is not bar
else
and then you can wrap it up and you can
say print i don't
know what this is
now i i'm so glad i actually
accidentally ran into this issue
as you can see now the editor is kind of
going crazy and darts not understanding
what this statement is
and
as we talked about it previously um
strings in dart are preferred to have
to be kind of like created with single
quotes however
if your string in itself contains a
single code for instance in this case
the word don't
contains a single code then dart kind of
gets confused like okay does the string
in here you can see it's
up until this point is it's a green so
it's thing it's thinking that oh the
string ends here but what is all of this
then that follows
if you have that problem
there are two ways of fixing that either
you
scape your
single code and that is a
that is a software kind of development
lingo escape kind of if you hear that it
pretty much just means that you're
um you are
kind of
wrapping it in a way
that dart understands that you don't
mean it literally you don't mean that
i want to end my string here except that
this needs to be escaped and put in the
string as its own value basically it's
kind of difficult to explain but i think
you know what i mean um so that's one
way of doing it it's a little bit dirty
so
in case you run into this issue it's
best to actually wrap your entire string
in double quotes and this way
then dart understands that whatever
comes in here is okay like a single code
is completely okay
unless you actually want to have
a double co double uh
double quotes in your string that is
enclosed with double quotes again so
you'll see if i put a double quote here
then dart goes crazy so you can escape
it with a backslash like that
so if you have single codes and double
quotes in your string then you will have
to kind of pick a convention either you
enclose the entire string in single
quotes and scape your
single quotes
inside that string and let the double
quotes live or you enclose your entire
string in double quotes and then you
will
escape your double quotes in the string
i hope i hope that makes sense
so
that is
um if and else in um in a nutshell
but before i move on i kind of want to
explain an important concept here in
that when dart executes this code it
kind of goes by line by line so it
starts with line seven the execution of
this test
function and then it come comes here and
it says okay name is foo all right
um
and it's actually saying that we prefer
const so let me change that to const
okay so
um
and it says
okay if name is foo
all right then it comes over here but
let's just change that to foo with
triple o
um actually
yeah let's no let's not do that let's
keep it as foo so it says if foo is if
name is food then it says yeah that's
true
and then it goes here however as you can
see the line number 11
also says if
name
is not bar
then it should execute this as well
and
and you can see that foo is not bar so
this condition is also true
however this this this will never be
executed and that is because
when dart goes inside these curly
brackets then it says okay i did what i
had to do i did my print statement the
rest i ignore
so if an if statement is kind of like a
is a
it puts a stop when it when it falls
into one of these if statements it kind
of says okay i did my job in this entire
if else block then i will execute the
code after that so if i clear the
console here and press command s you can
see it only says yes it is foo it
doesn't come here
so however if you change this
um condition so that the
dart compiler or
basically the execution of the program
doesn't fall into line number 10 it will
eventually fall to line number 12. so
you can see it says this value is not
bar so when you're writing your if
statement and else statements just be
careful with that just know that it's
kind of like a as soon as the code jumps
into one of those branches it doesn't go
to the rest of the branches and checks
them basically
all right
okay
that was for if and else
now let me
check that in my notes that we've talked
about that
what we need to do now is to talk about
operators
they
there are three different types of
operators there are prefix operators
infix operators and suffix operators
and
and i will explain them to you i mean
how they work um
i think to explain operators probably
it's best that we talk about numbers so
let's go in this test function and
delete everything that we we've written
here and let let me just say final
h is 20. all right so
um
now we've created a variable whose value
cannot be changed after spin assigned to
because we created as a final a variable
whose value is 20. all right now if you
want to calculate half of this value how
would you do that then well there is an
operator for that and that is a division
operator so you would just say for
instance final
half of age as you can see we're using
camel case as i explained in the
previous chapter
an easy way to do camel case is to say
half of it just writing in english
change the first letter of
of like this here change the first
letter of all the words except for the
first word to uppercase and then remove
all the spaces that's camelcase
basically so half of age is age and then
there is a great operator in a dart
called a division operator and then you
would say
all right
and then you could just say print half
of h
so command s and that says ten all right
so that's the division operator and then
you will have
let's say final double
the h
and then we will say h
multiplied by two it's kind of like a
star
that is an operator and you can see
these both operators this one
the division and the multiplication uh
multiplication it's a little bit
difficult to say
operators are in fix operators and an
infix operator is an operator that has
two parameters one to its right and one
to its left i don't know how you can
actually
yeah one two one to each side i don't
know if my video is like mirrored so if
my right hand is actually right hand on
your side as well so i don't know yes it
is probably
so
these are infix operators when they have
two values one to each side
however there are also
prefix operators
and
an example of that is for instance if i
said final
h minus 1
and actually we
change this to var i'll explain soon why
and if we said minus minus h
now this is an example of a prefix
operator and a prefix operator is an
operator that it comes before
whatever it has to do its work on and in
this case this minus minus operator what
it does is that it takes the value that
comes after it
it
decreases that value by one
and then it returns its result back to
the left-hand side so in this case the
the interpreter comes here and says okay
you wanna calculate something okay it's
equal to
oh a prefix operator that takes a
variable here and it says okay what is
age is 20
minus 1 is 19. puts it in here and it
also puts that minus 1 sorry puts that
19 in an h so
i think so at least so if we say print
age and print age minus one now both
should kind of be 19
and you can see it says twice you see 2
19. so that kind of means it's uh twice
so flutter has this great ability not to
duplicate basically log statements or
print statements
so
we have i mean there are some really
great operators in dart and that is the
plus operator operator and then you have
the minus division multiplication and
then you have the logical kind of like
operators to check if a value from the
left is equal to the value to the right
so
these are kind of like the basics of the
operators in um dart so you don't have
to know so much more about these for now
i would say
um
you can get really far with these and a
lot of these operators actually work not
only on numbers but also on strings so
and for instance if you this is one of
the cool features of dart which i
absolutely love i think it was just such
a great idea for them to implement this
like
uh one thing i mean if you're not coming
from a software development background
um you may not know this but if you're
coming for instance from design
background also you would notice that
sometimes when you're creating designs
or
any any screen and you want to kind of
like show that design to someone like a
product owner you want to actually
populate the text inside your design
with some lorem ipsum
and lower mibsum is basically has a huge
history of where it comes from but it's
usually some sort of a dummy text kind
of that you want to place inside your
design
so that you can just like display and
show it to someone
and
a lot of developers like in many
languages when they want to display some
text and they don't know what to say
like we're just testing stuff i just
want to display some text they go and
grab lorem ipsum and then put it in
their code
but dart has gone to the next step and
said okay we don't need that so what you
can do you can say for instance name is
foo
that's a string name but you can say
name times 20
is name times 20. you can literally say
multiply a string by 20 and what that
does is that it
says foo 20 times
so if i say print
name times 20
you can see it's
20 times so
it's a great feature you can say foo bar
pass
and then just say times 100
and yeah it just
that's it copies it for you 100 times in
names time
100 for instance so
so that is a um
that is
shortly said that is
the basics of operators in dart okay
i'm gonna delete that code
i'm gonna
mark in my notes that we've talked about
that
now i'm just gonna quickly
also mention
that
um
we can also create custom operators to
be honest with you and
i don't think it is completely
all right right now to talk about custom
operators i think it's kind of like a
topic to talk about later so i actually
just moved it in my notes that
we don't need to talk about it right now
because we have to know about a little
bit about a little bit about classes and
objects so that we can after we've
created our own class then we can create
custom operators as well so
i don't think it's completely
appropriate to talk about right now but
just know that in the future you can
also create your own operators and then
like or you can also override like
different operators and how they work
with different objects so it's it's
really fun
um
but that's that's that let's just let's
just leave operators to that for now
now the next topic that i wanted to talk
about is lists
and
a list in dart is
a series of
things that are
similar to each other and they are
placed inside
a list as you would have for instance a
piece of paper and you could write your
shopping list or like a christmas
shopping list or whatever
and it's numbered so
um these are called lists in dart
so for instance if you say
foo
and then bar
and then bass as you can see dark
doesn't like this syntax at the moment
it says okay what are these like what is
this uh
uh
comma here
the way to tell darth that this is a
list of things that are like in place
one two three
is by placing them inside uh square
brackets and then a semicolon of course
now
um
as i've talked about it before just just
now actually lists have
indexes in that they all have their own
place placement inside the list
and all these objects as we call them
they have their placements inside the
list and you may think that object
number one is foo and then
object number two is bar and now number
three is bas and i kind of correct but
index says in
i mean all the programming language that
i've worked with c plus c rust
dart swift
javascript
they pretty much all start at the index
of zero and that is so important to
understand because like
the placement of this object
called foo inside this
list
is not one it's actually it's index is
zero
and that is why lists are called zero
based and their indexes are called zero
based indexes so you've got to be
careful with that and we're going to
talk about indexes soon actually
so let's just say
final names is that now if i want to
extract foo from here i'm just going to
say
final foo is names
at the index of zero right i'm just
going to print it i'm just going to say
printfu and you'll see food printed here
now if i say
i want to get past then i'm going to say
print sorry
index of three
and you'll see
oh sorry
index of two because it's the third item
but since indexes are zero base then
it's in excel so i made the mistake
myself so command s and you'll get bass
and
i actually want to go back to this three
and then command s so you can see what
happened here you'll see you you'll get
something called
a range error which is an exception
an exception in dart and many other
programming languages is when things go
wrong
so that the language doesn't really know
anymore what you mean
and in this case you can see this
through an exception at the language
level or at the library's level where it
says
there are no four items in this array or
in this list because the index of three
indicates four items
item number one in the list has the
index of zero item number two has the
index sub one item number three has the
index of
two
and item number four has the index of
three
and there are only three objects in this
array or in this list so
zero index zero one two
so that's it
and index of number three is
non-existent and that is why we're
getting this invalid value not in
inclusive range zero to two
so
that's how you access items inside a
list
and this is how you actually create a
list okay so you say list of items which
is full bar bas so
you can also there are some convenient
um
properties on lists that you can for
instance say
final
length so if you want to know how many
items are
in this list you can also say
names
dot
and then you would say linked
we're going to talk a little bit about
that now as well because i think it's so
important to understand what that is
dots in dart and in many other
programming language is a way to drill
in to
something to extract something else from
it and in this case names is a list
and
all lists in dart
have
something called properties
length is the property of
the list data type in dart
and that means every list in dart has a
property called link that is
automatically calculated for you you
don't have to do anything as you enter
values in this list this length is gonna
then return the right value to you so
i'm gonna i'm just gonna talk about that
a little bit more so i'm just gonna say
print named length
it's gonna say you'll see here
let me scroll a little bit it'll say
three three items in this array
i'm gonna change the names list to var
so that we can actually
um
change its contents and mutate it like
i just wanna add a new name to this
names and i'll just say add
is a function as you can see because it
has parentheses right after it
so and i will say
um
my name and then semicolon to end the
statement now if i say print names
length right after the statement
you guessed it oh i can see actually my
um
you may not see all the print statements
because this text is right there so
let me resize my visual studio code a
little bit so you can see things a
little bit better sorry about that
so
now we have names length here and you
can see the second time around it said
four
okay
so
when you say dot after
the name of a of a variable and that
means it can be a constant a variable or
a final variable after you put dot
after its name you're accessing
different properties or different
functions inside that thing okay so it's
kind of like an accessor it allows you
to drill down inside an object and grab
things out of it or maybe make that
object do something for you okay
so
i think i think that's good enough to be
honest with you about lists i don't want
to go too much into details and scare
people about like all the different
things you can do with lists and but
there there is great documentation on
dart's own website all you have to do is
just to google or duckduckgo or whatever
you want to use bing
your
your way through and just search for
dart arrays documentation or just dart
arrays and then you will find lots of
information about it
or sorry dark lists because in dart
they're actually called lists in some
other programming languages they're
called arrays but
those names can be used interchangeably
to be honest with you lists and arrays
are kind of like yeah almost the same
thing so
all right um
that was lists in dart i'm gonna take it
in my
notes so that we know we've talked about
it
the next topic that i wanted to talk
about in this
video
are things called sets
all right and
as you can see in the caption i've
written here is a list of unique things
whereas
lists were lists of homogeneous things
sets our list of unique things so
i think the best way actually to explain
sets is just to jump right into it so
the syntax for a set is with a curly
bracket and
actually i think i think it is
yeah i think so
so let's say final
uh names and i'm just gonna say curly
bracket foo
and then end that okay just like that
now if i type names here
you will see that the suggestion
provided here or the information
provided by visual studio code says
names is a set of string
we talked about this in the previous
chapter that
when i say final names
or final something name for instance is
foo
i'm kind of telling dart to create
a variable
whose
reference name is name and its value is
fu and dart automatically understand
that the data type of this
value is string because its data is
string so you don't have to say final
string name
although you could do that but let's
change this to const as well as
and
you don't have to actually say this is a
string because dart understands it
automatically so you just remove the
data type if that's what you want to do
which is what i actually prefer to do
instead of being too verbose
unless you have a really good reason to
provide the data type anyways let's go
back to sets so
we were
here
means and that's and in the same way
that we created a string and then dart
automatically understood the data type
by putting uh square brac sorry curly
brackets here or curly braces here and
putting some data inside that dart
automatically understand okay this is a
set of some stuff in here and this stuff
for now just looks like a string so
if i say foo bar
as
um
art says okay this is fine but if i go
in here and i say foo again you can see
i automatically get then an error
message say saying two elements in a
constant so literally cannot be equal
because it understands that this foo it
has already repeated there
okay so let's remove foo from here and
let's do an experiment
let's change this names to var so that
we can actually change its con its
contents
then go to name and add to the next line
and say names if i can spell
and say add
and then say foo again
and then say names add bar and then set
add bas
or sorry means advanced
and then we'll say print names okay and
i'm gonna clear the logs with this
button right here
and then i'm gonna press command s
and you can see that the set is still
full bar bass nothing changed really
there
that is one of the greatest properties
of
lists
of um
sets in dart and in pretty much every
other programming language that supports
sets and that's
sets only ensure always that their data
is not duplicated and
this is i mean there's lots of magic
happening in the background that i
haven't really talked about in i mean
for instance like the question that you
may ask how does dart know
foo is the same as foo does it compare
them yes it kind of does actually
um
it's internally doing a comparison
between these things but we never told
it how that comparison should work
and that is because
if you remember from operators when we
talked about it the string
now we haven't talked about classes well
i'm just going to say strings in dart
already know how they should be compared
with other strings
okay
so
they
they kind of have this logic of hash
codes and comparison operators that they
know exactly like okay
given this string am i the same as that
like given sorry given what i am
and this new thing that you're providing
me like i'm foo and you're saying foo am
i the same as foo and then it says yes
or no so
that is what sets are doing internally
but we don't actually see that so
um
just know for now that sets in dart
allow you to create unique lists of
things okay and then
you may also be a little bit like
tempted to go and say okay i have things
here let's say const things is equal to
foo and then we say one
and this will also work and that is
because
dark has
the concept of object as well you can
see you'll see things and it'll say oh
now it's a set of object
we haven't talked about objects yet and
if i look at my notes i can see that
we're going to talk about objects in
chapter six
and we're right now in chapter four
so we haven't really
gotten to that point to talk about
objects
and i don't want to really scare you
about objects and what they actually are
but just know that
there is a hierarchy of data types so
you have object and then you have
data types that kind of derive their
functionality from objects so
here sits object and then here's its
string integer
double etc and then you have sets and
blah blah blah now
when you're here when you were first
here and you said i have foo barbaros
all strings then dart was like okay
this is a set of strings
but then
you said oh i have a string and i have
an integer which is a number
now dart was like oops i have i can't i
mean
i don't really i can't say this is a
list of strings and integers that's not
possible in there so it says i'm going
to take the common denominator type that
sits above them as their parent to
specify what these things are okay
and that is kind of like the same thing
that we do in real life in that if i
give you for instance um uh
two candies like a twix bar then you say
then you would say
this is a twix bar that's one thing
if i give you 10 twix bars then you will
say a lot of twix bars or 10 twix bars
if i just give you a bunch of twix bars
oh that's a bunch of twix bars but if i
go and
like
blend like lots of twix bars mars bars
whatever all the sweets into a bag and i
give you that bag what do you call it
you don't say
oh this is a bag of twix and uh snickers
and this is a
and mars bar no you would probably just
say candy it's a bag of candies and
that's what dart is doing here saying oh
you threw a lot of stuff in here i i
can't
like comprehend that this is a set of uh
objects
so
we do that in real real life and that's
what dart is doing here so just when you
see object just know that oh dark
doesn't really know what this is anymore
so
or it kind of knows what it is it's just
a
bunch of stuff so
that's what object in this case means
so that was a weird uh
comparison maybe but i hope you get uh
what i mean
and if you see me looking here it's just
because i'm looking at my notes to
ensure that i've explained the things
that i've
set out to explain so
talked a little about about hash codes
and sets we don't have to go into
details about that so
now let's go and talk a little bit about
maps
um
and
maps are kind of
one of my favorite data data structures
in
any programming language that supports
them pretty much almost all modern
programming languages support maps so
a map is
a data structure
as you can see here maps are used to
hold key value pairs of information and
what that means is
um
let's say that you want to explain
a person using their different
properties
then you would say age
their gender
their
hair color their
heights uh whatever
name all that so
these are kind of like your keys
so
you would explain
the properties of that person using
those keys and all those keys have their
values so
if you say height then you say like 180
yes
and if you say weight then you select 70
kilograms
so these are key values the keys are the
properties of that person and the values
are the values of those properties so
and the way to create a map is very
similar so to very similar to a set with
a curly with curly brackets
so you say person
and then you say equal to
actually this is just a name you don't
have to say person but yeah or you can
just say const so person and then you
open curly brackets and then you would
do your keys here and i would say the
key of age for instance i'll say 20
and then you say
column
is it calling yeah it's a column
and then you end the whole set with a
semicolon so i just created a
basically here i created a map whose
keys are string and values are integers
now let's see if dart understands that
you see this is it's a map of string as
keys and means as values but now
as you saw before the analogy of candies
now if i say okay i have another key and
it says
um
name and i say oh the name is foo
dart's going to be like oop
what is this person oh it's a map of
string as keys and object as the value
because it just looks at the common
denominator of the string which is foo
and 20 which is an integer and says oh i
don't know i can't create a map whose
keys are string and its values are both
string and integers so i'm just going to
go to their parent and be like oh the
parent of both string and integer is
object so your values are of type object
so
a bunch of candies basically okay
um
that's how you create a um
you create a map in dart so
and the other property of a map is for
instance you would say
um
if you if you go and create an agent
again here
you see it says two keys and a constant
map literal cannot be equal so it's
doing some checks here making sure that
the keys are actually unique so keys
inside a map
need to be unique all right so however
if you go and change this and say var
person so and then you later go and say
person
name is equal to foo like just like that
and then you print the entire person
so i'm just gonna say print before
and print after okay
and you can see here it said first time
h key is 20 it has a value of 20 and the
name k has the value of foo with a
capital f then the second time around on
the print statement on line 15 then we
when we print the person it has
the
um
key of age with a value of 20 because we
didn't modify that and a key of name as
it was before with the value of foo with
like six i think uh capital o's
so this is how you would modify a
map
you would specify the key
and then you would say equal to which is
an operator and then you would say the
new value all right
um however if you added a new key here
for instance um last name
and you say bad
and that will just kind of like get
appended to
the um to the map so age the same name
the same now you have a new key whose
value is bas all right
and that is kind of like the basics of
um
maps so
there are lots of things you can do with
maps and i really encourage you just
like everything else that i talked about
in this chapter that you go and read
some of the documentations because
if you're following along with this
course and your goal is to become a
software engineer and if you're for
instance a project manager or a designer
ux or whoever you are
um
i think you need to understand that
software engineers
do not know all the answers you have to
go and read documentation you have to
practice practice practice and put time
into it
countless countless hours you need to
put into learning so
i
i mean this course i think is going to
be so many hours long
the the way i can i mean i can see
uh the planning for all the chapters
that i put here
there's so many chapters i think the
entirety of this course is gonna go over
20 hours so you can imagine i can't go
into details about every single thing
otherwise it is just
this course is probably going to be like
200 300 hours
uh it's unbelievable so
we can't do that so what i expect you to
do now is just to open your browser and
just type dart
maps documentation something like that
dart maps
so
and you also need to know that now that
you're starting to google things you
need to be aware of the word dart and
that dart is an existing very popular
name for just darts
darts okay
so sometimes depending on what you're
googling
if a topic related to
the classic darts that you throw is more
popular than the topic of the
programming programming language which
kind of sounds the same
it may pop up first so
in this case if you say dart map
you may actually end up in some sort of
weird website that
explains to you how you can throw darts
at a map
i don't know i'm just trying i'm just
trying to bring it up because that i
actually ended up in that situation that
i searched for something related to dark
i actually ended up in a weird website
talking about darts as like a sport
so
know that as well please
all right now we've uh talked about maps
so i'm gonna take that in
my notes um
now
what's coming in the next chapter
we are gonna talk about a very um
important concept in dart and many other
programming languages such as rust and
swift and that is null safety or dart
calls it sound the sound noise safety it
is a very important thing to know about
in dart
and it will greatly help you in the
future as you write your flutter
applications and in this course i'm
going to use a lot of um
null
i'm going to
make a lot of null references talk about
null quite a lot throughout the course
so
it is very important that we go through
that as soon as possible and we're
definitely not gonna leave that out so
that's gonna be for chapter five so
keep an eye out for chapter five that is
to follow so i hope that you enjoyed
this chapter chapter number four where
we talked about dark control statements
and collections and i'll see you in the
next chapter
hello everyone
and welcome to chapter number five of
this vlogtech course
in this chapter we're going to talk
about null safety
um
in the previous chapter chapter number
four we talked about
dart control statements and
collections
and before we go on to talk about
enumerations and objects and classes
i feel
it is very important to talk about null
safety which is a concept that is
available in most most modern languages
such as
dart sorry such as rust and swift
so it is important to kind of like get
this out the way before we continue
maybe not even get it out of the way but
actually like
learn what it means and try to utilize
it so that we can write better code so
um
i thought to just bring up um
the concept of
null values and why they're important to
handle well
i mean you've seen so far that we have
data types a data type can be for
instance a string can be an integer
and then you can put values in them
um however
in programming languages you're also
allowed to
have the concept of the absence of a
value so
on one hand you have values so you for
instance have a string value equal to
foo bar or your name or whatever it is
and then on the other hand you can have
the absence of that value so you can see
that
okay i have a container i have a
variable that can contain the values of
type string or i have
a variable that can contain any object
however at the moment i don't have that
value so you will just tell dart that
this variable that i have right now
that can either contain a valid value of
type
object or of type string or
integer or it can sometimes also
during its lifetime
contain
nothing
and this nothingness is the concept
that is known as null um
so it's
null in dart is a keyword um
it means that it's a word that you can
just write in your text editor as you're
writing your code and you say that a
variable's value is equal to null
and this tells dart that well okay this
variable at the moment doesn't contain
any values so null is
not really a value but it's actually the
absence of a value you should think of
it that way
so
let's have a look at this um
there's a little bit of a documentation
here um
uh on dart's website dart dev null
safety so i'm just going to click on it
you're not going to see my screen at the
moment
i'm just bringing it up in a
browser
a browser window i'm going to bring it
on the screen
and increase the size a little bit and
also change the
sizing on the
window as well so you can see the
contents in its entirety um
so
as you can see in dart it's called sound
null null safety and there's
documentation about what this actually
means
um
we're gonna look at uh
[Music]
look at what's not safety actually means
in dart and i'm gonna give you a lot of
examples of what that actually
practically means and there's
documentation here in dart's website
simple simply because dart um
in its older versions and not in its
current versions it in its older
versions it didn't support uh all safety
so there was a lot of code written
manually by programmers in order to for
instance check whether
a value is absent in a variable
and then there is as you can see here it
says migrating an existing package or
app so there is documentation written by
the dart team in order to help
developers understand how they can move
their old code to the new code
that supports null safety
um however if you're following along
with this course and you're it's like
you're
basically just following chronologically
from chapter one to all the other
chapters i don't know how many chapters
were going to happen if you're following
along with this course you don't have to
think about migrating because the code
that we're writing in this entire course
is going to be null safe meaning that
we're going to take advantage of darts
null safety operators and meaning that
we are not going to manually check for
values being null and then doing some
branches of code whether they're null or
not but
so what i mean is that if you read the
documentation for sound safety you don't
have to worry about the migration parts
just read the rest okay
so
with that out the way i'm just gonna
make sure that i take that in my notes
here that's why i'm looking in this
direction because i have all my notes
here
um let's close this window and bring up
our
visual studio code window that we had
from earlier i'm gonna put it here
and i'm just gonna ensure that it is of
the correct height as well so you're
gonna see it the window in its entirety
okay
so
now that we talked about what non-values
are and that they're the absence of a
value let's have a look at
making any type nullable
and if you follow along with the
with the course up to this point you
should have some sort of a simulator or
an emulator running and then you should
have done command shift p or control
shift p
uh depending on your operating system
command shift p in mac and ctrl shift p
in linux and windows in order to bring
up the um
this menu and then you can just type
flutter select device and then you just
select the device that you want to run
the code out so i'm kind of assuming
that you've already done that and that
your code is running and this is
something that we talked about in
earlier chapters so we're not going to
go through that again
so i have a
an iphone simulator which you cannot see
on the screen but i have it running in a
separate uh screen just because we don't
have enough
real estate i can bring it up to this
window but it will just take a lot of
space so i'm gonna bring it up to
another monitor so you don't see it
so this code at the moment is running
live so if i press command s then it's
gonna run and just print the output for
us okay
um
now
let's talk about making any type um
nullable
and there is a
way to do that let's let's have a look
here
we talked about that null is a keyword
and that that's why you can see it is
like um
highlighted here in a different color
so if you for instance say final
name is foo
all right
as you can see it says okay i accept
this as his name is foo but you can't
just say name like it's a null because
then it doesn't understand is it an
object is it's a string is it nil right
is it an integer and if you type here
name then you see it's just dynamic it
doesn't understand the type
so
and we'll talk about dynamic a little
bit later um but what you can do is to
actually specify that okay i want a
string data type that
it can contain
normal names or strings as we call it
like series of characters or it can
sometimes be null and in that case you
have to actually specify the data type
as
um not just string
not just this because you'll see you'll
get an error
and you'll actually get a suggestion it
says try changing the type of the
variable or casting the right hand type
to string
but we're not going to do that wasn't it
such a
it wasn't such a useful suggestion
because what you want here is to
actually make dart understand that this
variable right here or this constant
right here can sometimes contain the
value of null
and the way to do that is you
put a suffix after your
data type as a question mark
so this is this is the syntax which is
actually used in some other languages as
well it's used in swift as well
so
um this tells dart that well here if we
make it actually variable as you can see
or sorry like this so you say i have a
variable
it's it's a string but sometimes it may
the string value may be absent
um and then you'll just say okay
now name is foo
and you can say now name is no
so this is kind of like resetting out
names so if i just say okay print
name
and then after foo i say print name okay
so let's just clear the console and just
run this application you can see the
first time it says it's null
and then the second time around it says
it is foo
so this is how you tell dark that you
want
to have nullable
data type and you can do this with
pretty much all data types so you can
just say okay i have an integer
um of age and that's 20. but you can see
you cannot now assign the value of null
to integer because it's not nullable but
as soon as you make it nullable then
that is accepted so
um and of course you can do
um
you can do different operations using
for instance we in the previous chapter
i believe we talked about control
statements if and else
so you can say for instance if age
is 20
and then you can encode or you can say
if age is null
execute some code
so they work as you would expect so
there is no difference really
and
i mean if you if you think about that
notability nullability is just like a
suffix to a data type you can also say
okay pretty much any data type can be
nullable and that's that's correct like
for instance if you have
a list of string
of names
and you can say okay i have foo
and bar here this is a list of strings
i've talked about lists in chapter four
now you can you can see here that list
of strings there are two data types here
the list itself and the
contents that it holds so if you want to
make the list in itself nullable then
you would put the question mark after
okay this means this list of strings in
itself can be absent so you say name is
null and that's accepted all right
however since you're telling dart that
okay the names uh value here can its
entirety be null
but its values are not supposed to be
null
so if you then go in here and just put
null in here then you see that you got
an error
and that's because dart is saying that
okay you just promised me that
the list in itself it can be absent but
as soon as
it is not absent meaning that as soon as
it is present there
with some values it's the values cannot
be no and that means that the
this type should be
you're telling me here that it is not so
if you want to make an optional
or nullable
list of
optional strings then you would put the
question mark after the data type of
string as well
so this is now
i mean the way you should read this is
i have a list of strings and i call that
list names
names can sometimes be no
meaning that it can be absent
and
if it is not absent
it can contain objects of type string
that themselves can sometimes be absent
meaning that okay like for instance if
you say
fu bar no that's accepted but you can
also say names
is no
see what i mean so both the container
which is called names and the values
that it contains can be optional
and the word optional is very important
for you to learn it's it's kind of like
an
industry accepted way of talking about
nulls and nullable values so
this is optional all right
okay um
now we talked about that
nullable values and optional values all
right basically you can use those words
interchangeably so
if you're talking with a colleague
programmer you would say oh how would
you describe this okay this is an
optional list of optional strings or you
could also say nullable list of nullable
strings but
optional is also word that is typically
used to talk about
nullable values all right
okay we talked about making any type
nullable so um
i'm just gonna
mark that as
done that we've talked about it in notes
all right
now let's talk about cherry picking
non-null values and what this means is
with dart you can easily
ask the
language to
give you
values that are not null
at all i'll explain what this actually
means let's say that
you have a um
you have a string
final um string first name
and is equal to foo
okay
now let's just say
this is a constant all right that's
that's what the suggestion was you see i
wrote final because i was not planning
to
reassign this first name value to
anything else but then i got a
suggestion to actually use the word
final here or the keyword final sorry
the keyword comms as you can see here
so let's say const
all right
um
now
what we want to do here then is to
also create a last name
or middle name
r
and then we say last name
and actually what we're going to do is
we're going to say the first
the first name is null all right
so first name middle made bar and last
name bass
now if you want to
if you have these values and you want to
for instance
i mean right now you can actually see
the values that you put here but
sometimes these values are passed to
your function so you don't know what
they are right now you can see what they
are so it's easy if i told you pick the
first non-null value then you would say
middle name because you can see it
however if you had a function for
instance test here that accepted those
values for instance string
first name
string
last name and then string
or yeah middle name etc then
you wouldn't know what those values are
or you cannot make an assumption about
what those values are except that they
are nullable or optional strings so
i hope that you get what i'm trying to
say now if someone told you to pick the
first non-null value
one way to do that is like the old way
of doing that is to say for um
if
first name
is not snow
um then you would say oh i again okay i
know first name
is the first non
small value okay
and then you say okay if first name
isn't null then we pick it otherwise
else if
middle name
is not null okay
and then you say okay
middle name is the first nominal value
and then else if again so last name is
not null
then you would print the same thing so
this is very repetitive
um
and it's basically
so it is basically
very verbose in the in the way it is
created
there is a better way of doing this and
that is with the
uh question mark question mark operator
in
dart which is available in some other
programming languages such as swift as
well
so the way to do that then is you would
want to pick the first non-null value so
you would say
final
or const first non-null value
and you would say that's equal to first
name
or or so this is kind of like question
mark question mark
middle name
and then question mark question mark
last name
so
and i mean we're getting a warning here
just because dark understands already
that this middle name although a
so it's this is although an optional
basically it has a value
but if we make this null
so and that warning goes away but i mean
it would probably be cleaner if we
actually pass these as parameters into
this function so we don't get these
weird warnings
but the way the question mark question
mark operator is working is that it says
it is an infix operator just so you know
in in from chapter four you know an
infix operator is an operator that has
two
things
and one on each on each side the right
and left
so in this case on the right side we
have middle name and on the left side we
have first name so what this operator
does it says if the value on my left
side is null
i'm gonna pick the value on my right
okay
and let's now in this case say okay
middle name is not now so what it does
it says first name or you null yeah
you're not then i'm gonna go to the
right side middle name are you no no i'm
not no then it's gonna pick that and the
rest of the
statement is not gonna be executed
however if middle name was also known in
this case then what happens is that it
begins from the left is a first name or
you know
yes middle name or you know yes so this
entire
operation here
it doesn't yield any value
and then so this entire operation will
let me know so it says okay now i have
to compare our
left left hand side are you know yeah we
know that this entire thing was no
and then it says right hand side are you
null
nope i'm bass then it takes pass so
the
this question mark question mark
operator is a null aware operator that
picks either the left side or the right
side
whichever one is not null first in that
order so left side are you null
if you're null i go to the right side
but if you're not not
not null i'll pick you
so keep that in mind it is a very handy
operator and it will
shorten your code quite a lot all right
now if we then go in here and say first
non-null value you can see it actually
says oh it's a string
however if we
if these were parameters so if we said
first name
and then string last name sorry middle
name
last name
they were not provided to us like that
converter was okay and then we say final
now
if we say first non-null value in this
case since it is a normal case
excuse me
where the dart compiler isn't working
with constants
and then
it cannot resolve this to a constant
value at the moment so it says okay
there are three optional values i have
no idea what they are
so
i'm gonna do my best to pick the first
nominal value depending on i mean based
on what we provided here
however i may not be able to solve this
so
the final result here as you'll see is
and it's an optional string meaning that
well i may not be able to resolve this
meaning that this entire operation on
top on line 9 may result in a null
all right
sorry about that sorry about my voice
so
that is the question mark question mark
operator so i'm just gonna mark that
that we talked about it in my notes
okay
so
that was that um
now
let's talk about the next topic uh which
is the null aware assignment operator i
think that's that's this actual official
name
um this operator is very similar to the
question mark question mark operator in
that it
it tries to resolve
a variable
to make sure it is not null
it's going to do its best um and let's
have a look at an example let's just say
um
bar
and i'm gonna say actually let's just
say
ring
and name is first name so we begin we
say that we have an optional name
and we begin by assigning first name to
it so it means that
this name might at the moment depending
on the value of first name it may be
null
and now
if that is null you may want to assign
another value to it all right
and then you can do that with this
operator you would say last name
let's see what happened here
both trying to oh is it this yes it is
equal to so i actually should change
this
case to equal to
question mark
yes and i'm going to bring it up again
so that it is actually correct let's say
and then name equal to
isn't this working
lastly oh
dummy
where was it this one
try changing the
it like this
i'm actually a bit unsure right now so
let's have a look actually what this
does
um
and it's three positional and then we
say no no
no and then bar
and then baz here okay so
first name is null
middle name is bar and last name is bass
and
to be honest with you i mean this is
quite a lot for me as well it is
something that is like the
syntax of the programming language it is
something that you will kind of need to
live with you're not gonna memorize this
all just in in your head all the time of
course like the main parts of it you're
gonna you're gonna remember but
uh not all of it so and you can see for
me as well i'm just like at the moment
okay which one is it um
so i'm gonna test that so i'm to begin
with we say name is first name and
if that is null then assign
actually let's just say middle name
name here then use middle name and then
print the name finally
and i can see it says bar here so it's
actually question mark question mark
equal
um
so i actually maybe need to edit this
text one more time so i'm just going to
say question mark question mark equal
bring it up because i think question
mark equal is not going to work an equal
question mark isn't going to work either
it's not a value it's not a valid syntax
a question mark question mark equals
sorry about that
so
what this operator at the moment is
doing it says that i'm gonna take the
value on the left hand side and check
whether it is null or not if it is null
then i'm gonna assign the value on the
right hand side to the left hand side
if it is not null i'm gonna leave it
alone
okay
so
at the moment first name as you saw here
is null
the first parameter that we passed here
so what it says it says okay i'm going
to check then for middle name
if
if name is null and it is null and then
it says okay middle name are you
like presenter and i will assign that
value here so it will be
um
[Music]
basically it will be bar which is the
value of the milling
now if we
in here said
middle name is also null
right we could have another operator
here that says okay if after taking the
middle name we are still null then take
the last name
so
and you can see bass gets printed to the
screen and that is because because bass
is the last parameter that we're
checking on line 10
and its value is not null
um
so you can see how like if i then went
here and actually said the first name is
bar then you will see that that will be
the value that gets printed to the
screen here
because
right here
name or first name which is bar got
assigned to name so it is an optional
string but it has a value which is bar
then when you come to this line number
nine then you're telling dart look if
name is null then assign middle name to
it and dart says well
name isn't null it is bar so i'm not
going to assign middle name to it and
then it goes to line number 10 and does
the exact same thing all right
so that is like the null aware
assignment operators and uh
it is useful
i personally i mean to be honest with
you i
as you could as you could kind of guess
i don't use this operator so often it is
there
and i have no shame in saying that
pretty much in none of my programs have
i had to use this so it is present for
you to
use it is available if you want to use
it so just
don't be like me but try to remember the
syntax this question mark question mark
equal
okay
and i'm gonna actually fix that in my
notes as well that it is question mark
question mark equal
okay
and i'm going to check it in the notes
that we've talked about it
now let's talk a little about
a little bit about conditional method or
property access or conditional
invocation
now
as we talked about in the previous
chapter with dart as like many other
programming languages you can
use the dot syntax
in order to access or drill down inside
properties and methods or functions
inside other objects as we saw for
instance with the case of
or lists in dart you can say
i have a list and then you want to get
its length then you would say
the name of the list dot links and that
drills down inside that list and gets
the links property okay
however as you saw also earlier in this
chapter in chapter number five
even lists or pretty much any data type
in dart can also be nullable
so how do you access
properties of a null object so let's
have a look at that now
let's say i'm gonna i'm gonna actually
delete these properties uh the
parameters that come here to our
function
and i'm to say and i'm going to go down
here and remove these parameters as well
and in here let's just create an
optional list of strings
not optional list of optional strings
but at just an optional list of valid
strings okay so i'm just going to say
list of strings as an option i'm sorry
an optional list and i'm just going to
say means
and that is equal to let's just say at
the moment foo all right
now
in here if you try to say final length
of names or number of names is names
links
okay
if you then look at the data type here i
mean we could actually say this is null
okay
and you can see
here dart actually is allowed to
or is able to give you an error
knowing that this list it is null at the
moment however if you accept it i think
it's actually better that we accept this
value as a parameter so that dart
analyzer cannot be too smart about like
making assumptions about what this
actually is at the moment so
you can see the
analyzer is telling you it cannot be
unconditionally accessed because the
receiver can be null and that means yeah
exactly as it says it says names can
mean all i don't know if it's not right
now or not
but it can be
so how do you access that one way to do
that like the old way of doing that is
to say if
names is not null
then length
is named length okay
uh final length is
uh in x okay so that tells dart that
look i'm actually checking for null
values
um or i'm checking that this list is not
null on line eight
and if it is not null
then i would access its length property
and this is kind of it's called type
promotion
and type as in data type
so in this case you can see on line
number eight
or now if i go and create a new line on
number online number eight and i say
names
this is an optional list
that can contain strings
and in here
you can see it is um it is typed as the
same but it is promoted to not being
null because you've already checked for
it because if you remove these lines of
code you can see now that you get an
error the exact same line but if you
check first for null and you don't get
the error it's a type promotion okay
so this is kind of like the old way of
doing that
um
so let's say that you want to have you
want to extract the length so you say
final length or means length
right you create the variable but you
don't assign anything to it
when you say if names is not null then
the length is equal to name's length
otherwise length is zero okay so this is
one way of doing that
is the old way of doing that
and
you may be
trying to be smart as well and say okay
i don't need this else statement if i
just say this is a variable
and by default is zero and yeah you
would be right because length is zero by
default and then if names is not null
then you say okay length is equal to
names length
however there's a better way of doing
that and that is using the
quest dot question mark i believe or the
question mark that actually it is yeah
operator which conditionally executes
or invokes a method or a property inside
an optional if that optional value is
present
i'm going to show you how to do that so
if we say final links
is names and then you would put question
mark dot and then you would say links
and you would see this this code like
being executed without a problem
however if you go here you would see
that length is an optional value it's an
optional integer so
you may be like okay how do i solve that
how do i say that
i want length to be zero
if
this length value is
null meaning that if it's names if the
names list is null and we can't extract
the length then i want this value to be
set to null and that is using our
question mark question mark operator
that we talked about the null aware
operator that we talked about earlier
the infix operator
so you could just do this you would say
length is
if the names list is present meaning
that its value is not null then grab its
length otherwise take the value of 0 and
assign it to length and if you go to
line number nine now and i say length so
you can see it's an integer
so it's not
um
is not an optional integer anymore
so you could do the same thing as well
like you could say names
and you could do the same thing with
properties and you could also do it for
functions so you can say names add
as
right so you see this is a function
called add and then we're adding the
value of bass to that list
however you can't
unconditionally invoke this function on
an optional value because
it might be null
all right
so
that is like a very very important
bit of learning about dark
learning about optionals in dart how you
could use
nullable values and
as you will see and we'll talk about it
more in this course um
there is
many cases where you have to
um
take into consideration all values and
especially if you're working with
different libraries where
the library cannot make too many
assumptions and your code is dependent
on the library and
you will have to take into consideration
okay the absence of a value means that i
personally have to like take some
um
decisions in my code consciously in
order to execute bits and pieces of code
depending on the absence or presence of
the value so try to use these optional
um
null aware operators that i taught you
here which was
um the null aware um basically like the
decision making on to pick like the
infix operator that tells you whether
the left hand side or the right hand
side depending on which one is not null
first it picks that one okay
that offer is very important and the
um
all over invocation operator which is
here so you say some object which may be
null then do something on it
or the
operator which is a null aware
assignment operator that assigns the
value on the right to the variable on
the left should the variable on the left
be null all right so these are very very
important to understand
okay
um
now that we've talked about that i'm
gonna take that in my notes that that is
a topic we talked about
now
we also have um
very very good official documentation
about null safety in dart so i'm gonna
bring up this documentation on a
separator separate screen
and then i'm gonna bring it up here so
you can actually see as well all right
um
you can see here it says understanding
all safety and this is great great
documentation
about how null safety in dart works
as you can see a lot of examples um
i mean it talks about like from the
absolute beginning
what it actually means
uh and you can see here null is at the
level of object so it's not novel itself
is not like an object
so you have lists and doubles and
integers here but null sits on top for
itself it's kind of like the absence
of a value
so there's lots of examples in in this
link and i
highly encourage you to have a look at
it some things you may not understand
for instance like this one you will
understand easily because it says there
is something called a thing like a class
but we haven't talked about classes yet
and its
name parameter name here in this
function called showgizmo is called
thing and you can see it is
conditionally accessing a property on
that thing
so
and then if that property in itself is
null it conditionally access that as
well so if this property is nullable and
then it's accessing another property
inside that nullable property
if it's not null so it's i mean it's a
great way you can chain them as you can
see here so
then so if this thing is not null then
conditionally accesses this property on
that so it's it's beautiful i mean and
this thing is available on many other
languages like rust and swift as well so
it's nothing new it but it is kind of
like
uh such an important topic to understand
in dart that i think you shouldn't just
skim over it so you should just really
learn how to work with it so
all right um we've now talked about null
value so i'm going to take that in our
in my notes here
now i think for chapter 5 five
this information is enough so that we
can move on to
the next chapter
and in the next chapter chapter number
six we're going to talk about some
really really juicy stuff and
this is like chapter six is going to be
like um
as i can see my notes are pressing in
a lot of really interesting
topics such as enumerations classes
objects
custom operators constructors factory
constructors class methods
i mean inheritance and stop classing
apps subclassing abstract classes so
as you may have heard
depending on what background you have
you may be like a product owner or
product designer a ux or whatever you
may not have like a software engineering
background but
dart is um
in its core it's an
object-oriented programming language it
means that things in dart are objects an
object is an instance of a class as
we'll talk about in the next chapter so
um
for you to understand dart and how these
things work for instance we've talked
about lists and actually typing dots in
front of the name of the list and
getting its lengths but you may not
really know how that works so in order
to understand all those things what that
dot means you need to understand what
objects are in order to understand
objects you need to know what classes
are and when you understand classes then
you will learn about inheritance and
then you will talk we'll talk about
abstract classes properties static
functions all that so
what we're going to talk about in
chapter six is so
important that i believe that every dart
developer needs to know about this and
we're learning all of these things to be
become good at doing flutter um so
uh although you can go and write like
servers or maybe server applications
with dart or you could write command
line applications with dart but these
days
dart is primarily used for writing
flutter applications and i don't have
any
data to prove that but i can see for
myself when i'm in the community that
most people are using dart primarily to
write flutter applications so we're
doing all of this to learn more about
flutter and i highly recommend that you
don't skip these chapters where we're
talking about art especially if you're
new
to flutter development so with that said
let's leave this chapter the way it is
right now chapter number five we're done
with that let's go to chapter number six
and learn about dart enumerations and
objects
welcome to chapter six of this flutter
course
in this chapter we're going to talk
about uh dart enumerations and objects
and these are some of my favorite things
to actually talk about so
um
in most programming languages actually
have the same facilities so
if you follow along with the other
chapters then you should have a working
dart project set up now and maybe
running in an emulator or a simulator so
that you have the ability to press
command s on mac or control s in linux
and windows in order to rerun your
project so without you having to pretty
much do anything so
let's then get started i'm just going to
make that assumption that you're already
set
with those requirements
so
let's start by talking about
enumerations and i'm gonna bring up
the project from the previous chapter
let's just make sure that it's on the
screen so you can easily see it
now i'm going to go and to this list
function that we created remove the only
parameter there and remove that as well
so if i press command s now nothing
should happen on the screen because we
don't have any functionality in tests so
let's talk about enumerations and what
they actually are as you can see here
animations are named list of related
items
now
an enumeration is
kind of like equivalent of
making a string written programmatically
so that it becomes an entity
and by that i mean that
let's say you have the
value
name
and then you could say foo
and you would also say khan's other name
that's also foo they're both the same
string but they're not the same identity
in that
i mean internally actually in terms of
const i don't want to go too much into
the comp how the compiler actually works
but they're going to be going to be the
same string
but i mean that you've written it twice
so it's not the exact same thing you
have to write it twice
so an enumeration try to tries to
basically
make sure that
a value has a name that can be
programmatically referred to so
let's say
um cons sorry enum and that's a key word
in dart that's how you create an
enumeration
um i'm going to take this that we've
talked about some some other things
during the intro sorry about i have to
look at my notes anyway anyways so we
have the enum here that's how you create
an animation in guards
and you would and then give a name to
your innovation and unlike variables and
constants that they're
written with camel case you'd have to
basically use another casing here which
is the first letter of every word in
your iterations name has to be uppercase
and the and the rest of the letters have
to be lowercase so
let's in this case for instance say
person properties okay the properties of
any person
then in this enum you will write the
different properties for instance first
name
and lastly
page
so what that basically means is that
you've now defined a list of related
things such as first name last name age
which are categorized under a particular
name which in this case person
properties okay
and you can refer to these in your code
using the dot notation so you can say
person
properties
first name okay
and we can print it actually so i'm just
gonna press command s and you can see it
being printed to the screen so
um
i mean immersions are really really
great as we go on in the in learning
about dart and how dart works how we can
work with flutter how we can parse data
that comes back from a
a server for instance
but for now it's enough for you to
understand that you can categorize
related items
under an enumeration so that you can
refer to them later okay
and indoor you can also get the string
representation of these uh
values using their name property that is
something that's created for you by
default so if you just say name
you now see first name being printed to
the screen as a string but before that
if you print the innovations
value here for first name it would print
out the entire thing okay
so that's
short and sweet about enumerations we're
gonna use them quite a lot
actually
especially later where we go to more
advanced topics
as we develop our real application but
for now just know that this is how you
create an information using an enum
keyword and then the rest of the
properties you just put in curly
brackets okay
so
that's for
enumerations um
now we need to talk about switch
statements and actually let's bring this
back and i'm gonna
change this to properties let's say okay
and let's just say for instance animal
type and let's say cat um
dog and then let's say rabbit
maybe
so
let's say we have an animal type
enumeration and um
we want to
and then we for instance get in our
function we say animal type
animal type so there's a property that
we expect to be passed our function
called animal type and then
we name that property animal type with
kennel casing here okay so if we do that
then we go to our function here we're
recalling the function you can see that
we got an error meaning that there is a
parameter expected of type animal type
and no one's passing them
so at the call side which is
the place you are calling your function
that's what a call site is known as in
programming so if you're coming from a
background of design or
um anything that is not software
development related so you wouldn't
probably know
so much about the this kind of lingo but
a call site is where you're calling a
function so at this call site online
number 19
um we're gonna gonna pass an animal type
and let's just say uh cat in this case
okay
so in here we could just print that and
i'm just gonna say animal type
i'm gonna press command s and you can
see cat being printed here okay
now if you want to execute
different types of code depending on
this animal type
then you could you could which is not
recommended you could use an if
statement so if you just said if
animal type is equal to animal type cat
you say print all i left oh i love
cats okay
else if animal type is animal
and you would say prince or
or you would say dogs are so fluffy or
something
and else if
animal type is animal type
me
and say
i wish i
had
so this is using normal if statements
you say if animal type is cat then blah
blah blah
now
it is one way of doing it but it's not
the recommended way of working with
enumerations and the recommended way of
working with enumeration especially if
you're doing like branching code as
we're doing here is using a switch
statement so
let's convert this code to switch
um
so let's say switch
you put parenthesis open close and then
open close curly brackets and in here
you would put your narration so you say
animal type okay
and the way to handle these different
branches then is with the case uh
keyword you'd say in the case of
animal type
money
print
uh money
sound like this okay
case animal type
a cat
print cat
and case animal type
og print dog
just like that okay
now
this is i'm great i'm actually grateful
that we're getting this uh error so you
can clearly see what it says is the case
should not complete normally try adding
break or return now what this is saying
that you see in
many programming languages just like
dark when the program comes here to the
case statement it kind of like falls
through to the next line and dart tries
to avoid that so it says okay if i
handle bunny then i'm doing some stuff
but it kind of feels like i'm like
falling down to the next line after this
because you didn't tell me what to do
after the print statement so you either
tell
me to like completely go out of this
function go out of the test function by
putting the return keyword here we
haven't talked about return really yet
but you could do that you could just say
okay return right after all of these so
i'm just going to press command s
and you will see cat being printed to
screen which is here okay
but if you didn't have this return
statement statement here you would get
an error okay
so
you either say return
or you would use the break keyword now
there's a difference between these let's
put a print statement here and i'm going
to say function is finished okay
so i'm kind of expecting that
by
executing our
our code here our test function here
passing the value of cat at the moment
that we fall into the switch
we check that this is cat and then print
the cat and then we return okay
this is kind of
what it is doing it means that it kind
of skips over this print statement and
you'll see soon if i say command s it
will just say cat and then we'll return
from that
so this is not really what i wanted i
wanted this switch statement to be
executed print cat and then continue
after switch okay and that's where you
use the break statement so
or the key word here so if you say break
it breaks out of the switch statement
and then continues with the rest of the
function as it as you would expect so if
i press command s here you say cat and
then function is finished all right
so
switch is the preferred way of working
with um
enumerations especially if you're doing
branches so you could also like
um
for instance if in this case he said uh
pray make sure
this is
is a cat
you could also in this case say if
animal type
is not animal type
chats
and you would return okay you could do
this as well so this is kind of like
a conditional statement that you're
putting in the beginning of your
function making making sure that any
code executed after line 10
is
completely sure that the animal type is
a cat okay so in that case you may just
use a typical if statement so you don't
have to do switches okay but if you're
trying to execute spec special pieces of
code depending on
which value this enumeration contains at
the moment
then i highly suggest that you use
switch statement instead of if statement
all right so kind of depends on your on
your use case all right
okay i'm just going to mark this item as
done in my notes
now let's talk about classes all right
which is one of my favorite topics to
talk about actually
um
well classes in
uh dart and in many other languages
let's actually bring this back to how it
was before make it a test function all
right
and remove the animal type from here and
remove them i can actually continue and
we can actually
as well okay
so classes in dart are
are grouping of various functionalities
into one packageable piece of data
and and by that i mean for instance
let's say that you have a function
called run
another function called breathe
and then you have a person's first name
a person's last name
of course you could go and define these
things like this you could say khan's
first name
yeah something and khan's last name is
something
like this
okay
um just like that and then you could
have a function and sorry you would say
run
um and then you'd have another function
called breathe
you can do that but these are functions
that are kind of like for us in this
particular case or at least in my head
at the moment i'm imagining these
functions
to be related to a person
and that person can run that person can
breathe that person has a first name and
last name so the grouping of these
related things
is
done with a class
in dart at least so
the way to do that is you would say for
instance class which is a keyword in
dart
let's
say the name of the class now for the
naming of classes and enumerations and
any other
entity except for variables and
constants
you should use um just normal casing you
would i don't actually know if it's
called pascal casing or i think so
um
but you would just use your upper case
the first letter of every word okay so
let's just say person
okay this is how you would say a person
class all right so
i don't think actually we can put const
in there i'm just gonna grab
these two functions and just place them
inside this person class all right
and let's in this say print
running
run function and with reading we're
going to say breathing
all right
and in the test function you would want
to
create
something called an instance of this
class now
instances are objects and objects are
created from classes so
you need to understand how
instantiation
works in software development and this
is for any programming language such as
dart
rust
swift python javascript where
they
allow you to create classes
and now that you know what a class is
in order to use a class you need to
usually create something called an
instance of that class that means that
you tell
the programming language that okay here
is the class i know about that but give
me a copy of it
so
every class
can be instantiated meaning that the
dart compiler will create a copy of that
exact class with its data its functions
its properties and give that copy to you
all right so
that is called instantiation and it
works by using the equal sign and
creating putting a parenthesis
at the end of the name of the class as
i'll show you here so let's just say
final
and we say person
which is the name of our variable in
this case is equal to as i said equal
sign then we would write the name of the
class and parenthesis just like that
okay
so now you said a person variable in
this case is an instance of that person
class
now you'll understand using dots and
notation you could say person.run you
see
that function is now available on your
instance of the person class and you
would say person
dot
breathe okay
so these are
functions that are available at instance
level of the person class i know there's
a lot of words that i'm just talking
about but i think you understand the
point here so
this is how you instantiate the person
class and this is how you invoke various
functions on that class so if i press
command s you can see it says running
and
if you said in this case person
and then without instantiating using
their
parenthesis if you said breathe
you will get an error here instance
member breathe can't be accessed using
static axis
okay and
that's i mean that is kind of like
instance member is an important term
also to remember an instance member
means some functionality that is only
available at the instance level meaning
that it's not available at the person
class level but you have to make a copy
of person in order to be able to access
that all right
so
that's
the basic of classes
you can do a lot with classes as we will
talk about soon so i'm just going to
leave that person class right there
and then
just going to mark that as talked about
in my notes as well
and let's now talk a little bit a little
bit about objects
well
objects are actually quite easy to
explain an object is an instance of a
class so
you wouldn't like
when someone says oh here's an object of
type string it means literally that
there is a class called string i've
created an instance of it and
and that is an object so the word
instance the words instance and object
are usually used interchangeably uh but
if you hear someone say instantiate a
class then you would say okay what's the
class name oh it's person all right
and person
is now i created an instance okay and in
this case you can see i'm just creating
an instance of person without actually
doing anything with it so that's got
kind of like a useless object all right
but if i put i say foo as a person
then this
foo now is an object of type of person
and actually you can write its name here
and you'll see that it tells you that
this is a person okay
so that in short is what
um
objects are
and i can see my notes that objects need
are kind of like in the wrong place i'm
gonna bring it to the right place sorry
about that um
okay
now
let's talk a little bit about um
constructors
and i can see constructors also at the
wrong place in my notes so i'm going to
bring those also to the right place okay
sorry about that
um
now what a constructor is at its name as
its name indicates is
a special
logic in a class that constructs or
initializes or builds that class's
instance all right so
you may say that okay let's go to our
function here as to our class here
person
and let's say every person has
a first name or name okay so let's just
define that we say final string name all
right as you can see now dart is saying
okay you said that every person has a
name but
and it's a final meaning that after the
person has been instantiated or after
that person has been initialized or
created an instance from you cannot
change that name because you said final
all right
if you said like string name is foo that
would be different because it means
every person instance that gets created
has the default value
foo for its name that's a completely
different way of saying
uh what the name of
in this case as you can see we're saying
that there every person instance every
person
copy that we create has a name now dart
to say okay where is the name then you
didn't tell me how to create it
and that's where you would want to use
something called constructor okay
constructors are sometimes you uh called
as initializers depending on the
background of the programmer they may
call it constructor initializer uh or
maybe some other names that i don't know
about but if you if you hear that a
constructor then you will now know what
i'm talking about
soon actually
so
now what you can do at least in visual
studio code when you get this error is
to just hover hover over it and then
press command on mac or control on
windows on linux and press dot
now you will see you will get some
suggestions here
and it will the second suggestion at
least for me here says create
constructor for final fields okay and i
can just press that
and what happens here now you see it's
that it creates something that looks
kind of like a function but it doesn't
have a name
its name is implicitly set to the name
of the class okay
so basically it says i'm a special
function with the same name as the class
and i expect a value to be given to me
which i will then in turn assign to the
name property of myself
it's kind of like a strange way of doing
things but it is quiet clean as well
okay
after you do that so this is how you
create a constructor after you do that
then at the call site where you're
calling this person class to create an
instance of it it will complain saying
that oh i'm expecting an argument
but i didn't find any
and that's where you have to pass the
name so let's say in this case is foo
bar okay
and then on the next line you can just
say print foo name
all right and press command s and then
you can see foo bar being printed to the
screen so
that is like the basic of a constructor
that's how you construct instances of
your class all right
now you may be saying that all right i
don't want
i mean you can do many fancy things with
constructors you could say okay
this name for instance by default must
have a special value you could do that
there's lots of things you can do with
constructors which i'm not going to go
into the details of
but right now just know that a
constructor is this special kind of
function that has the same name as the
name of the class
and then parenthesis and then you put
your values in here all right
okay
that was
constructors
um
now
let's talk a little bit about um
methods all right
and
what methods are
i'm actually going to go here and say
we're going to talk about methods
and those at the wrong place in my notes
as well sorry about that
a method of a class we've talked about
already to be honest with you and a
method of a class is
um
a function on the class
which
is usually referred to as an instance
method meaning that the function is
available after you've instantiated that
class all right as we're doing in line
number 14.
name is an instance variable
so is a variable that is available at an
instance level is not an instance method
an instance method should be a function
all right so let's go and create a
function here that doesn't return any
value denoted by the void return type
and we say print name all right
the
functionality of this function is only
just to print
class all right that's all it all it
does
and in dart you're also now that we're
talking about this i'll just mention
also in dart it's usually
better not to prefix your instance
variables or instance functions
inside the class itself using
this
keyword this
keyword in dart
that this this
or that this keyword
basically refers to the current instance
of this class all right
so you could either tell print name to
print this dot name or it's actually
better to remove this and refer to it as
name that's the recommended way of doing
it okay so avoid the keyword this as
much as you can
unless you have to
and we'll come to those points hopefully
later in this
in this course why you may have to do
that while you may have to use this
all right now we have the print name
instance method all right
so let's just use it instead of this
print function that we're doing here
let's just say foo
dot prints name all right command s or
control s
on linux and windows and command sun on
the macintosh and then you get the
flutter
foo bar printed here or you could just
say
print
i'm going to
i will now print the name of this person
in single quotes we don't need double
quotes okay command s and you will see
that message being printed here
followed by the actual name of that
instance so
if someone says method or instance
method you will then know what we're
talking about is a function created at
the class level that does some stuff all
right so that's short and sweet
um
okay
now that we've talked about that
let's talk a little bit about
inheritance and subclassing i'm gonna
bring a caption here so you know what
we're talking about
now
inheritance and subclassing are so so
important in dart
and in any other object-oriented
programming language that i don't think
anybody should like jump over it or
um like for instance i know
developers working in various
programming languages that are object
oriented but they kind of steer clear of
the object oriented aspects of that
language and maybe they don't need it
and maybe they just feel like it's
unnecessary or they feel like oh it's
just too complicated but in dart if you
want to become a good flutter developer
or a good dart developer you need to
know about
um classes and um
inheritance so
so let's
talk about inheritance what inheritance
in dart is is that
it allows you to
define a class
and then
to add more functionality to that class
into a new class
so
let's for instance say
we go into our test function here and
remove that okay
that code and also remove the person
class now
let's create a
class livingthing all right
and then we say funk
sorry void
breathe
and then we say print
living thing is breathing okay
so we created a class living thing and
we're saying that anything that lives
needs to breathe now this may be an
assumption but anyways
anything that lives and is above the
and it's above the ground and it's
basically alive is breathing okay
so that's our function on the living
thing now
you may say okay
any living thing may also have the
ability to move okay then we have a
function called move i'm going to say
print i am moving all right
so now you may say okay now i kind of
want a class called uh cats all right
cat is also a living thing
one way to do that to go about creating
a class uh
the cat class is to say class cat
and then you say um i kind of need these
functions and you'll go and copy it and
then you paste them here all right
and then you say okay i'm good to go now
but one of the absolute
paramount paramount
qualities of
a developer is the
developers do not like to repeat
themselves
and
it is such an important concept in
programming that you need to avoid
repeating yourself that you need to just
coin that down now
get it straight so that you don't
make this mistake as we're doing in this
code right now so
the first thing you want to do as a
developer say how can i grab this code
and
and it's obvious that the cat is also a
living thing so
that's where you want to use the extends
um keyword that allows you to inherit
the functionality inside the living
thing class into your cat class so
in this case i'm saying cat class
extends or read it in english as
inherits
living
thing all right so
you can see that the cat class in itself
is empty right now but if you go to the
test function and i say
final
fluffers
is a cat
and then i can say fluffers
uh you can see that now that the cat
class has breathe and move uh
functionalities or functions actually
so although cat itself didn't define
these functions but they're available
for the instance in this case called
fluffers of type cat to use so you could
just say move and then you can say
fluffers
okay
so if i run this code if i delete
everything in the debug console and run
this code you can see that the cat
instance called fluffer is the same move
or i am moving and it will also say
living thing is breathing okay
now
you could also i mean we could also talk
about now that we're talking about
inheritance and subclassing
um
actually maybe i shouldn't call a
subclassing but i also think it's
important for you to understand what
subclassing is subclassing is literally
the same thing as inheritance
subclassing is saying that you have a
class and you're creating a sub
component like a sub
thing of it
which may actually have
it's a little bit of a strange naming
sub because sub means kind of like a
subset of things available in that class
but it actually is like a superset
because
it will
grab everything like the cat at the
moment has every functionality in living
thing right
but it may not necessarily do that
it's kind of complicated to explain but
if you hear subclassing or inheritance
know that
that is what we mean
you
use the extends keyword usually okay
all right now we've talked about
inheritance and subclassing
so
i'm gonna
move a little bit uh my notes around
sorry about that that i'm looking away
from the screen and uh
now we're gonna talk about abstract
classes all right
there's good documentation about
abstract classes and
what we're going to do here
is to just change this class living
thing at the moment to abstract
and you see that everything works as
expected
well
an abstract class
is very similar to
a normal class and there's good
documentation about what an abstract
class actually is from a dart
perspective and you can see it says use
the abs abstract modifier to define an
abstract class class that cannot be
instantiated all right
so an abstract class is just like a
normal class that can't have instances
so
in this in this case once we made living
thing an abstract class if you then go
and hear say
thing
is a living thing
right
and
it says oh abstract classes can't be
instantiated
so an abstract class is a class that
groups logic into itself
with the sole purpose of other classes
using its functionality okay
so if you mark something as an abstract
class in dart you what you need to just
know in your head is that this is a
class that has some utilities that has
some code that is supposed to be used in
other normal classes all right
and no one is supposed to just go and
create an instance of living thing in
this case
instead
at the call side you need to instantiate
classes of that type so
now we can say cat as we did before and
we can say thing breathe move or
fluffers
so
that's what an abstract class is
it is
just a class that cannot be instantiated
it's usually like a utility class that
other classes are supposed to inherit
from all right
okay um
i can see now in my notes and i'm gonna
take that we've talked quickly about
abstract classes
and i'm going to bring
the next topic up which we're going to
talk about which are factory
constructors
so
i absolutely personally love factory
constructors to be honest with you
let's remove our abstract class i'll
explain to you what a factory
is let's see now we have a
glass cat all right
um and then in here
let's give the cat a name
of type string
command dot or control dot
for linux windows on the name in visual
studio code at least to create a
constructor you can do that and say
create constructor or you could manually
create a constructor so you say cat
this name okay that's a constructor
and also know that um you could make
this a const because it is actually
using a final field but we're going to
talk about that later
now we have a cat class here that has
a constructor called just cat meaning
that in here you can say
final
fluffball
is cat
and then you say fluffball
all right so now you're creating an
instance of the cat class and the name
of the variable is called fluffball
and the name of the cat is fluffball
right
so
then you can say print
off
ball
dots name all right
so
that
is just normal constructor it has
nothing to do with a factory constructor
but what a factory constructor actually
is
is a way for you to construct instances
of your classes
and using convenience functions
so what that means is that if you in
your code see that
you are creating instances of this class
like 20 times 30 times different places
in your application using this exact
same name fluffball
then
you need to then create a factory
constructor that is a clear sign that
your usual use case for create an
instance of class is
through
the same name of fluffball
so
that's where factory constructors are
useful for and as their name indicates
is a way to
create
a product like a factory does uh super
fast for you okay so it's the speed at
which you can create an instance of a
class that the factory constructor
shines at all right
so let's now look at a factory
constructor that gives us an instance of
cap whose name is always fluffball all
right
the way to do that is you would say
factory
and you would say cat dot fluffball
so you say any class called cat which is
this class has a function called
fluffball which is this factory
constructor and then you would put your
parentheses in here
and then what you need to do is to kind
of
set up your class instance in this case
like if you say curly brackets and say
this name
is fluff
like that that's how you're basically
creating an instance of your class but
the usual way of doing that is you say
this
name
dude let's see uh
factory cat fluff ball
and then you would say
name is fluff
see that i've kind of like forgotten the
um
uh
syntax for factory uh so let's go i'm
gonna bring up safari here and let's go
and say guard factory constructor
i'll bring bring up here factory
constructor so let's say factory
and let's go and see an example and you
can see here it says factory logger like
that okay and there's a factory logger
blah blah like that so
are basically so what what it's
basically saying in here is saying that
this in this function you need to return
something okay so let's close that
safari window and what we're going to do
in here we're going to say return cat
and as the name we're gonna say
fluffball all right so that's how you
would create like a factory constructor
so what you're doing here is saying that
i have a constructor called fluffball
whose return value is a cat
but inside i have some special logic
that kind of packages it up just like
you do in a factory so
let's go in here instead of doing cat
fluff ball like that then you can just
say cat dot fluffball okay so it kind of
like became a
um
it became like a convenient function in
that you can just say cat fluff ball and
then you say print
fluffball
dot
name and you can see by default it is
or whatever you put here
fluffball 2 print and it gets printed to
the screen ok
so that's how you would create a factory
constructor and a factory constructor is
really really important when you're
talking about class clusters
we haven't talked about class clusters
and to be honest with you i don't think
that we're gonna talk about that in this
course
i don't think anywhere in this course
i've actually talked about
class clusters
but know that
in the context of dart and abstract
classes a factory constructor does not
necessarily
have to return an instance of the same
class all right so it can actually
return
an instance of another class
but i highly suggest that you actually
go and read about factory constructors
as i just did just google
factory constructor
dart and you will see some examples of
it
um
they are really useful if you're working
with a lot of data and you're doing like
data parsing
json parsing etc
but
i don't think it's so useful right now
for you to know
but know that it is there available for
you to use but
i leave it up to you to go and read more
about it yourself
okay
and we've now talked about factory
constructors and um
now let's talk a little bit about
custom operators so i'm going to bring
custom operators here okay
now
a custom operator in dart is
an operator such as an equal sign or
equal equal sign for for instance
um checking equality um of an instance
of an object with another instance of
the same object
um a custom operator allows you in dart
to override the ability of your class to
be compared to or added to or
subtracted from multiplied with
something
with your own logic now let's see what i
mean by that let's say that
you have final uh cat one and that is
equal to cat with the name of foo
then you say okay i have cat two now
with the exact same name
and then you'd say if cat one is exactly
the same as cat 2 prints they are equal
otherwise say print they are not equal
ok
so
these two instances have the exact same
name
foo
and if you run this code now you will
see
that dart is said it says that they're
not equal although internally you may
think hmm
for me in my project anytime
two cats have the same name
i want them to be considered equal and
this is like where
things get interesting because then you
can override this particular
function or operator at the language
level only for your class so the way to
do that is you would go and start by
writing override
with an ad sign
and you say
bool operator equal equal covariance i'm
going to explain all this don't worry
about it cat and you say cat and then
here you say
um other
name is me okay and then we get a
problem with the hash
i'll add that as well
so don't worry about all of this um i
will explain it in details
um
all right so okay
so let's start by looking at what i just
did here with the override
notation here
overwrite is very important term for you
to understand in object-oriented
programming and that is
wherever you have
um
a class
and you are
inheriting from that class in in our
case for instance class cat you can see
that it doesn't have any extents
but by default in dart every class
inherits implicitly from the object
class so you could just say extends
object
and that is the exact same thing as
omitting writing that
those two words so
just know that cat comes from object
an object internally already defines an
operator called equal equal that returns
a boolean
a boolean is a value that can either
include true
that can either be true or false
and it's great just for saying that is
this this or is this that
is this this or not kind of like that
so a boolean is a data type all right so
that operator an operator is a keyword
as well in dart basically saying telling
dart that we are going to change
change as in override
the functionality of this equally equal
operator that is defined at the object
level with our own
implementation all right
let's actually bring the extents here
and go into this object definition just
select it right click on it and say go
to definition all right
and search for operator equal equal
you'll see that it is defined right
there for you okay
and there's lots of documentation about
what it actually does
so that's this syntax we're overriding
we're changing the definition of that
function all right
so
then since this is a simple function an
operator in itself is a function it
actually you can see it starts it has
like a
parenthesis here
in the parenthesis you get the value
that that operator is comparing your
class with okay so
it's that
that value that your class is being
compared to also needs to be a cat
because you cannot in dart is not
recommended that you compare tune
classes of different types with each
other so
here we say covariance covariance
is a keyword that you merely use in dart
but i think it's important for you to
understand what it does is
that it tells dart that although
at the object level
we said that the parameter that comes in
is of type object but in our case we are
sure that the value that comes in this
function is actually a cat all right so
covariant tells dart that
forget what the super class which is
object defines as the parameter type for
this parameter because if you remove
covarian you see it says cat
an object as a parameter
but if it's a covariant you're kind of
like overriding even that
assumption all right so we say okay an
equal so we're mean compared our
instance of cat is being compared with
another cath instance
and what we're doing is that we need to
return a boolean saying whether they're
equal or not and you can see i'm just
comparing
i'm just comparing the name which is our
name
with the other instances name all right
now when you do that as you saw then we
get a problem here which is kind of like
a warning that tells you that okay
now that you've you've overwritten this
um
operator you also need to override the
hash code all right
now
to honestly i don't think like hashcode
is such an important thing to talk about
right now but just know that hashcode is
a special number
that you assign
to your or a special identifier that you
assign to your instance of classes that
is
then used inside collections for
instance if you put your instance of of
cat inside
a
dictionary
then or sorry or inside a map as it is
called in dart which we talked about i
believe in chapter
four
yes in chapter four so if you didn't
watch chapter four i strongly suggest
that you do that
so
if you put instances of your
of your cat class inside a
set
or inside a map
then the way dart
knows that the the keys inside its map
or the values inside the set are
actually unique it's using this hash
value all right
so
if you see if i go here and say command
dot to get a suggestion how to fix this
it says create method hash code
that is what is required to fix this
word
so you can see that it's an override
which means that this hash code
getter was defined on the object class
if we go to object and look for that you
can see that it is actually defined
there
and we're overwriting its value
and here it says i'm going to go to
super and get that value
super is our object so as super class
that sits up above us all right
but if you want to overwrite that in
case you in this case you can just say
okay don't get the supers hash code just
get the name hashtag and to be honest
with you this is just a
very technical stuff which i don't think
belongs right in this chapter six but
just know that here we're creating an
identifier for our cat class
which allows dart to understand
that if this
cat classes instances are placed inside
collections such as a map or a set
then it will know
if they're unique or not okay
all right
so now that we've done all of this we
can rerun the code
and you will now see that it says they
are equal
that's that's all we wanted that's
really all we want
but there was a lot of code actually i
don't know it's like four lines of code
um
this is not even considered a line of
code it's kind of like a
is a hint to the analyzer but uh
so
you could just say it's pretty much just
two lines of code but it is quite a lot
of
new things to be honest with you for you
to
grasp
so i leave this here so you can have a
look at it
um and
i think
for this chapter to be honest with you
we've talked a lot now in this chapter
about enumeration switch statements
classes objects uh constructors
factory
constructors
abstract classes inheritance a lot so it
was quite a heavy chapter this chapter
six but
i suggest that you
go and read the also the official
documentation for dart because as i said
we don't have the possibility to talk
about everything
um
otherwise this course will just be
enormously big and that's not what i
want to do so
please go and read the documentation
about the things that we talked about
especially especially object oriented
programming in dart so
and with that said
in the next chapter we're going to talk
about some advanced features in dart
such as
future
async operations streams and generators
so
please have a look about at the
documentation and i will see you in the
next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 7
of this flutter course in this chapter
we're going to talk about advanced dart
concepts
things such as extensions futures
streams
um
async await generators and um
generics as well
so
uh i'm kind of assuming that you've
already set up the project that we've
talked about in the previous chapter so
i'm not going to go through that again
and then i'm assuming that we have like
some sort of an iphone simulator so
or an android emulator or any device
that you may be able to test your
project on so
i'm going to bring up my project here so
i'm going to place it right there
this is how we left the project in the
previous chapter
and then i'm going to do command shift p
on mac or control shift p in linux and
windows in order to select the device
and i'm just going to say iphone 13 pro
which is a simulator that i have here
um
right there and then i'm just going to
go and say run
run without debugging okay so this is
going to take its time and i just
thought to
then use this time to explain a little
bit about extensions
um
as you can see here extensions are
the ability for
the programmer and dart in order to er
are there the ability for the programmer
to
extend
or add functionality to an existing
class in chapter six we talked about
classes and objects so i kind of um
would
wish for everyone who is in this chapter
to act actually have followed that
chapter as well
uh i'm actually going to go here and go
to do not disturb yeah i am actually
there so let's have a look at a simple
extension in dart and how we can use
that i can see that the programming
program is running i'm going to delete
the old code that we had and i'm going
to bring my face to that bottom right
and i'm just going to be a little bit
aware of these um
captions that i'm displaying on the
screen and that they're blocking the
screen so i'll just make sure that you
can see the contents as
as we go on so
um let's also remove all of that and
then let's just say that we have a
simple cat class here who has a name
and we can go in here and say final
meow
is yeah an instance of cat and i can say
print
and me
actually we have to provide a name i can
see here and let's just say fluffers
and save meow
dot's name okay so we print that name
and i'm gonna say command s
just like that and um perhaps gonna
bring up visual studio code so you can
actually see the output so command s and
you can see that um
where are we getting this there are
equals oh that's an old command so
command is and you can see fluffers is
printed to the screen so that's because
we have the name here okay so i'm also
going to get rid of this caption right
now so you can see the entirety of the
code so like that bring it down here i'm
also going to get rid of my
simulator and bring it to another screen
okay so now let's say that you want to
add a functionality to this or a
function to this class
that allows a cat to run or allow the
cat to jump so one way to do that is to
actually go to the
cat class class itself and create a
function in there but what you can also
do is to go and say extension
for instance run on cat that's the
syntax for creating an extension what
you're saying is that
you're extending the
class call cats
with
a new functionality that is called run
now this is not the name of the function
itself it's just the name of your
extension
and you don't have to really know about
the name right now so much it's just
when you can go and become more advanced
in dart and you for instance create
libraries for yourself that
you
create extensions on different classes
for instance in your library and then
people or programmers who use your
library then they can in
basically include
specific extensions that you've included
in your library
in their code or they can exclude them
and so
just know that it's just a name on the
extension so it doesn't mean so much
right now okay so then you can just
create a function that has no return
value called run and then you can say
print and cat
name is running
and you know this syntax from the
previous chapters that this is how you
format a string and then in here you're
basically doing um spring interpolation
interpolation i think it's called
and you're including that name inside
your own string so the result is going
to be cat
space
the name of this cat instance
space is running okay
so
using that
then you can every cat instance in your
project is gonna get
that function called run so you can just
say me out run
and command this and you can see that it
says cap fluffers is running so
just know that extensions are
they're a great tool for you to use if
you believe that there is a
functionality that you're adding to an
existing class which it doesn't really
belong
in that class itself
but
it may for instance belong in the
current source file that you're working
with so
extensions are very very useful and
but i also believe that they need to
kind of be used with care kind of like
sparsely so when you really need an
extension you could just go and create
an extension and they have limitations
and as you get more used to
programming in dart you will understand
their limitations a little bit better so
just know that they're there
and
can be used another example of an
extension is for instance if you had a
class
person
let me say first name
property okay
so this is an instance property and then
you would say uh last name
and then you say command dot individual
studio code on mac or control dot in
linux and windows and you create a
constructor for your personal class okay
so that's how you create an instance of
your person class then you can go in
here and you say
um
final fou is person whose first name is
who and whose last name is bar okay
and in here let's say you want to be
able to calculate a person's full name
all right so what you could do is to you
could say extension
for me
one person
and then here you could just say i have
a i want to calculate the full name so
that the result type is going to be a
string
and then you want to create a getter now
we haven't talked about getter so much
but just know that it's kind of like a
property it's a property that can only
be read forever but it cannot be written
to so you just say get
and then you say phoney
as the name of the property and you will
say that is equal to
dollar first name
space dollar last name okay
so what you're saying here is that i
have a getter whose return type is
string and whose name is full name and
it returns the first name and last
memory with the space in between and
then in here you could just say print
foo
for me all right
and command s then i will bring the
i'll remove the caption so you can see
that foo bar is printed to the screen
okay
so that's for extensions and i'm gonna
note that here in my i'm gonna mark it
in my notes that we've talked about
extensions all right
now the next thing to talk about the
next topic is futures
and as you can see here future is a data
to be returned in the future as its name
suggests so
um
and that is part of something called
asynchronous programming if you haven't
uh been doing uh programming before you
may not be so
familiar with the term synchronous or
asynchronous um
a synchronous task is a task that
happens when you ask for it and it
returns with the data that you ask for
immediately
for instance if you say
um what is 2 plus 2 and then we'll say
okay it's four that's the synchronous
task but if you for instance say to your
um spouse or your friend
go to the grocery store today please and
get some milk
that is not gonna happen in this instant
it's i mean even if you even if you're
the grocery stores right next to your
house or your apartment then your friend
has to go
get get ready put put on shoes go to the
store get the mail can come back so
um that that is an asynchronous task so
an asynchronous task is basically a task
that
whose results are not returned
immediately okay
so
up until this point we've looked at
functions that i'm actually going to
remove all of this code from here so
that we don't have all of that
now we only have the void test function
in here okay
so
all the functions that we've written so
far have been synchronous functions in
that for instance you would say
string multiplied by
two and then it gets an integer of a and
it just says a multiplied by two all
right
and actually sorry hint so it returns an
integer the function call the function
name is called multiplied by two it
takes an integer as a parameter and just
multiplies that integer by two and
returns it it's a synchronous operation
okay however in dirt if you wanna work
with asynchronous operations that you
have to
use a class called future so
let's have a look at that um let's say
that you have a function
multiplied by two it which it may take
some time in order to multiply a value
okay this is hypothetical because yeah
the multiplication is going to be done
immediately but we're just going to
assume that yeah this is a complicated
multiplication and it will take some
time all right so let's say future and
then you would say what is the actual
future what does it contain what data
type can we say integer and then we say
heavy
future
okay
and it takes a value of int a heavy
future that
multiplies by two something like that
okay
so it says i return a future okay now
in here then your your
um
responsibility is to create and package
up an integer and return it inside a
future so
if you for instance in here say okay
return 10 okay
you see that it says l10 isn't
compatible with the future of integer
because 10 is a synchronous value it's
right there it's present so what are you
doing here then you could say
okay what i do return is a future
and then you could say oh i'm going to
delay this future
by a duration of three seconds okay
and then you'll see there's a second
parameter to this delayed function
um you can see it let's see
uh if we have a look at delayed function
in here you see there is a second
parameter called future or a computation
so
in here what you're what you need to do
is just to say okay
my second parameter is a function i'm
going to ignore its return value well
i'm just going to return the value of a
okay
so let's actually see if we say
future delay duration seconds and then
we say the parameter is let's say e
and then i'm just going to say return a
what is this value going to be then
you know what we could actually look at
the documentation for future delayed so
i can also refresh my mind
so i'm going to go and open a new safari
window and i'm going to say future
delayed
this is the type of stuff that usually
happens anyways if you're programming
with dart i'm also going to increase the
size so that you can see it a little bit
better
and let's have a look at a future delay
here
and
here we can see how it's constructed uh
how to use future okay
so you can see here that there is a
function that it doesn't basically take
anything any uh value so
i think the problem was that i may have
just created like a function that um was
expecting a parameter so
this is how you would do that and i mean
it is a little bit strange argument like
i'm actually going to clean it up a
little bit as well
and then make this a constant as you can
see it's suggested here and then return
so i've written a lot of code i haven't
explained really what i've done here but
i will do that now so let's see
uh we're saying that we're returning an
integer in the future so
it's not going to be returned
immediately it's going to take some time
for it to do its calculation okay so and
then here let's say a multiplied by 2 as
we as we promised in the function
signature okay so that's future int
this is the name of the function so
nothing magical about that and then it
takes a parameter that says integer a
in the function body itself we're saying
okay we're returning a future but we're
delaying its return by the duration of
three seconds so duration as you can see
is a class here if you go in it
actually is a constitution okay and then
there is a class on top probably
somewhere
uh let's see
constitution in blah blah blah
constitution duration operator i believe
this is i mean the duration dart it's
probably just a class duration
somewhere
if you look at here class duration so
so we're saying that we're creating a
duration as a first parameter to the
delayed function of the future so we're
saying that we're delaying this future's
return value by three seconds and then
it says okay i'm going to wait three
seconds but then i'm after i waited
three seconds i'm going to call this
function
and this is kind of like a shorthand for
creating a an inline function you could
also do it like this you say okay my
function that i'm providing to this
function so it's like you're passing a
function to the future delay function
and then in here you could just say okay
i return a multiplied by two and then a
semicolon so this is probably a little
bit easier to read so
um
now that we have that um
we could actually use this function in
our test um
in our test function so
when you then um
i mean now that actually we we've now
talked a little bit a bit about future
and in order to use a
future then you need to know something
about
async and awaiting dart
now
async and await
are very related to each other but quite
different in their meaning and
um
i just want to now explain actually
first async
async is a key word in dart that marks a
function as asynchronous in that
remember synchronous is something that
returns immediately and asynchronous is
something that does not return
immediately takes some time however to
mark a function async in here it means
that this function internally
can execute commands that do not return
immediately okay
so
ac marking a function as async it
it it means that this function
internally calls other functions that do
asynchronous work so
let's now say final um result is
heavy future
and we say 10 okay
now that we've done that let me just
print the result and you'd be surprised
to actually see the result
when we do that and you'll see that it
is not what you think it's not going to
be 20 okay
so i'm gonna get rid of this caption so
that you can see the the result and i'm
gonna clear the results in the console
and command s
and you'll see that what got printed to
the screen is actually the future is not
is not what you think it's not
the value 20 which should be a
multiplied by 2 which should be 20. so
what happened here is that when you call
a function that returns a future you're
actually getting the future back you're
not getting its data back
so how do you get that data back well by
prefixing the function with the keyword
await
so as its name indicates this
keyword is just going to wait for
the result of this function to be
calculated and then it's gonna go to the
next line okay
so
these two are very related to each other
and you'll see that if i remove async
then i will get an error saying that
well you said this function
called test is a synchronous function it
just returns void
basically means it doesn't return
anything and it asynchronously does its
work and doesn't
have to wait for anything so
but then inside the function you're
saying wait which means yeah i have to
wait some time for something and that's
not okay so
what you need to do then is you mark
your functions with async if internally
in that function you're using a weight
all right
and
the weight itself then is used for
waiting for the result of the future
okay so if you remove this async and
then you remove this await everything
will just work but it's just
synchronously getting the future of the
heavy future that multiplies by two and
printing it so it's not doing any
asynchronous work in here you can see
it's just getting that instance so now
that we're calling that let's command s
and you'll see it's waiting
three seconds and then printed the
result 20 to the screen okay
so
that for us was async and in weight and
we're going to use async and in a way
and await quite a lot in this course so
it would be really good if you could
have with this information that i gave
you if you could just have a little bit
of
a read about future like documentation
on the web
so if you just search future
dart um and maybe async await and
read a little bit about them because
they're so important in doing
asynchronous work in dart that we just
can't jump over them okay
all right um so now we've talked about
future
uh
and we've talked about async and awaits
so i'm just gonna mark them as
done in my notes
um the next topic to talk about
it would be
streams
so as you saw here a future in dart is a
class that controls the computation of
an asynchronous value in order to be
returned in some point in the future
however
quite often in
in your client's work or even server
work you need to do work that is
asynchronous however it is continuous
work for instance if you if like i have
the time uh displayed on top of my
screen on the right hand corner
that is a stream of
strings
it is a it is a stream because it
doesn't have an end ready it it's a
continuous pipe of information every
minute that
little ticker
up on top right it's gonna increase and
it's gonna go to zero six fifty zero six
fifty 651 so
it is continuously calculating the
current time and like sending it down at
this pipe
now in asynchronous programming and in
reactive programming
which you may also get into if you're
following with this course or if you're
following some other course you may
actually be interested in learning about
learning more about streams
and reactive streams
a stream is just a pipe of data
um that
either
it either completes
or it never completes
actually it completes successfully or it
never completes or it errors out and
dies okay so
um a stream of time up there you can see
it's not 0 6 50 in the morning and it is
a stream of data that never completes
because time is just just continuously
going forward okay
so when we talk about streams we just
mean a pipe of data a future
that
sends data down this pipe that
never ends
as you saw in the case of a future a
future ends it calculates its data and
it returns and it says i'm done
but a stream in dart
is a future that just continues working
okay so it calculates some data in the
future and it also sends it down the
stream and it says oh well i'm not done
here's another data here's another data
okay
so
let's have a look at this uh stream and
see how we can work with streams okay
so let's go and create a stream of um
let's say a string
and then we say get name okay
now in here
you your job is to create a string so if
you say return hello
see that hello is not compatible with
the return type that you promised it's
going to be a string
um so you it this is very similar to how
we worked with the
future of integer you couldn't return an
integer in that future but you have to
create a future of integer and inside
the function
return the actual integer which was the
computation if i go back you will see
that
code here right
the future delayed and inside this
function you're actually doing the
computation all right
so
how do we create a stream and you could
just say stream
and then you could say
okay periodic for instance or a value
okay if you say we return a stream of
value
and then you could say foo
is accepted
what this means is that you have a pipe
of data
but the only value that it contains is a
foo is the value of food that's it all
right
so let's now go into this test function
and try to consume this uh stream if you
just said
final value is gets me
and you just print this value
and then i'm going to clear the logs
here and say command s you'll see that
just like future it just says instance
of controller stream okay so it is not
the actual value inside the string so
the question is how do you wait for
values
inside a stream you could just say okay
await
it says okay you've
actually we could read this a weight
applied to stream string which is not a
future so
dart is understanding that okay you're
awaiting on a stream but
this is this is not just like a future
that you're gonna wait for there's
nothing to await like it's not a single
value is a stream so
the syntax to
do that is await
four
okay so this is a syntax
for awaiting for values inside a stream
then you could say wait for final value
in
its name okay
and then you could just print the value
so this is a little bit of a strange
syntax but if you read it in like in
english it makes perfect sense you're
waiting for values in get's name
if you just ignore the final in here
okay
but read it in english from left to
right await for values in get name
that's it
and then at the end i'm going to say
print stream
finished working
here the console command s
and you'll see it immediately said foo
and then stream finished working i'm
gonna clear it command s
foo stream finish working okay
so this is an interesting concept but
it's still not a stream really i mean
we're packaging the full string inside
the stream but
it's only one value we could have done
that with a future so let's take
advantage of streams actual
functionality of
sending down data in its pipe
continuously so what we could do in here
say stream
periodic it means periodically produce
values and in here you can see the first
parameter is a duration so let's say
constant duration
of seconds every second okay and then
there is a second parameter in here
that you'll have to provide if i move my
mouse over periodic you'll see that the
second parameter is this string function
int okay so it means that give me a
function that accepts an integer
and then it returns a string all right
and it understands that it needs to
return a string because you're saying
that your stream is a string if you
change this to an int and then went here
um to the documentation and the
documentation will actually or the
method signature will change to say that
uh your you should support you're
supposed to take an integer in this
function that you provide to me and then
you need to return an integer okay so
that string i just wanted to show you
that that string that was shown in the
function signature there it's because we
promised to return a string in our
function okay so
let's go in here
basically the function signature said
that you need to accept an integer so
i'm just going to say value
and then let's go in here
i'm just going to say return foo
so we basically
conform to that function signature we
said we take some value and you see the
value is an integer
and then we're returning a string okay
so now we can consume that so if i clear
this log and i say command s you see
that every second the value of foo is
going to get printed to the screen and
that's
actually i need to remove this caption i
can see you can't see it
you see that 10 times 11 times 12
14.
so all right
um i'm sorry about that the caption was
blocking the screen i wasn't aware of
that um or actually i was aware of that
but i forgot that that was the case in
in this as i was talking
so you can see that every second the
stream is sending a value all right now
that's that's basically the gist of
using streams
you will
i'm wondering actually if we're gonna
use the streams in this course i believe
at some point we are
i need to probably look at the um
look at my notes
yes i can see that we're actually using
streams in this course so
don't worry about
if you don't fully understand streams at
the moment because we're gonna talk
about streams and
um
because we're gonna actually talk about
streams and stream controllers later in
this
in this
course so
just know for now that a stream is like
a future but it
continuously or periodically can return
values and then you can wait for
those values using the await for
syntax and dart okay
okay
um
now
the next topic to
talk about
in this chapter is generators so
generators are very very interesting in
dart
some other languages also support
generators and
but not not all modern languages do that
so
a generator in dart is a function
that returns
i don't want to say iterable but it
returns a list of things
but it
internally calculates that data in a
very simple way
that's the best explanation i can come
up with to be honest with you let's have
a look here
i think the best way to do that is
actually write a function that does uh
creates a generator okay
um i'm gonna clear this um
and then we have a test function here
let's mark lacing okay
um
let's now go create a generator and
let's say
we want to
create a function that returns the
values one two three
um
so
a way to do that is would be to say i
want a list of integers okay and my
function
or get one two three like this
and you could say return one two three
like that okay so that's completely
valid
another way of doing that is to use
something called iterable
and iterables i mean you need to
understand what iterables actually are
and they're kind of like lazy
collections and when you get used to
doing more software engineering you will
understand more what
why we use lazy collections
but for now just know that an iterable
is a prepared and packaged up list of
things
but it is not
it is not completely calculated when it
first begins
it's kind of like
it's kind of like how a restaurant works
in a typical night a restaurant might
have for instance 50 customers
and
when that shift begins during the night
not all food is ready i mean it can't
possibly be like when cut the first
customer comes in we can say that the
food for the 50th customer is already
ready in the kitchen
that's how a restaurant works it it
listens to orders of its customers and
then it generates the food based on the
orders that's how an iterable works okay
however a list in dart is an already
packaged list it means that it's as if
like you go to a supermarket and then
you buy
ready ready to go
food that's already packaged 30 packs of
that that is a list that is 30 ready
readily packaged food items and then you
take away that's how list works but an
iterable is more like
it's
it's a list of like things that gets
calculated on the go
on the fly all right
so
um
just know that for now so we just said
either well and as you can see dart
understood that okay a list is also an
eye trouble so i don't have to worry
about that so it didn't give you an
error
so let's go and actually instead of
doing one two three let's go and mark
our
um function as
uh a generator and you do that with
either sync or async okay
so and this would be a stream like
now the difference between sync
with a an asterisk an async with an
asterisk is
a sync function is an
it is a generator function that returns
a list of things but it calculates that
list of things
asynchronously and as you can guess the
async equivalent of the sync asterisk it
does the exact same thing but it returns
a stream
and which means it's asynchronously
calculating its result okay so
when you mark a function as sync you
don't then go and return
like this because you can see that you
can see that it says you're creating a
generator function so you have to kind
of calculate your results now you can't
just return a bunch of things to me okay
so
to do that you would use a keyword in
dart called yield
now yield is
a very interesting keyword that you
would use only in generator functions as
far as i know
and in here you're telling dart that
okay the first value that i'm outputting
in my iterable is the value of one so
if in here we went and said
um
i know or say we say four value in
gets one two three
and then you could just say print value
you can see it only prints the value of
1. i'm actually going to get rid of this
caption you can see the output
it only prints the value of 1 just
because we yielded the value of 1. okay
so you could just send then say yield
one yield two and yield three
then you'd see the values one two three
so
in this function internally then you
could do a lot of other important things
maybe some synchronous uh some other
synchronous calculations and every time
you have a value to output
then you would basically
um
you would do a yield and you could also
print the entire return value
yes you don't have to do a four loop
so you could just say print it and then
it would say one two three okay
but if you do a for loop then you're
actually taking advantage of that lazy
um
capabilities of an eye turbo so you
could break out the loop at loop at any
time you could just say
print value
if value
is two
then you could break okay
so let's clear the logs and command s
you'll see only the value of one and two
gets printed and then as soon as you're
at the value of two then you're breaking
and that means that this yield
was basically never calculated so that's
that's like the beauty of
generator
functions
so you could also create asynchronous
generator functions as i mentioned and
that means that you're kind of like
creating a stream of iterables
to be honest with you asynchronous
generators i've i've maybe used them
once or twice
uh in in the many years i've used dart
so
i don't think you're going to use them a
lot but just know that they're there and
you could use them by prefixing your eye
treble with a stream
saying that basically you're returning a
stream of eye troubles and then
suffixing your function with async just
like that all right
so and then here it says okay you said
that you're returning a stream of ideal
integers but you're turning only one
value in here then you would just say
okay one two
okay
um but then you would say yeah then you
have the ability to do whatever you want
here like return an actual eye variable
okay so i'm not going to talk about
asynchronous generators to be honest
with you in this course because they're
kind of like outside the scope
so just know that they exist and you can
use them
okay i'm going to mark in my notes that
we've talked about generators so
the next topic to talk about are
generics
and i'm going to bring up a caption here
so generics in
programming languages that do support it
are
there so that you avoid writing the same
code over and over again okay
so
let's say that you i mean this is a very
typical
example i know it's a little bit cliche
but
i think it's cliche for a reason and
that's because it's such a good example
um
let's say you
have a class
that stores
a pair of data let's just say class
pair okay
and then in here you could say okay what
pair of data do i want to store okay i
want to store
value one as a string and i want to also
store value two as a string and then you
create the constructor for it okay
all right that's that's great it's a
pair of strings but how do you then
pair an integer like two integers then
you would say okay
i have to have another pair class and
this one is an integer
but then you have this problem because
pair is already defined as a class up
there on line seven
so you cannot reuse that you cannot have
the same name then you would say okay
pair of
integers
and then here you would say pair of
strings
and you make sure that the constructor
name is also
correct
now
i mean you may have also i mean in this
point at this point we don't have logic
at all in these two classes you may have
actually quite a lot of logic in your
classes but
as i mentioned i think during one of
these chapters i think it was chapter
one or two program one of the main
characteristics of software engineers is
that we all dislike
um writing the same piece of code over
and over again so
we try
to as much as possible avoid
um repeating ourselves
so
that's where generics can come in so
what you could do is instead of doing
this pair of pair of
let me bring this here let's go and
create a class that is generic and you
would say pair
and then a format for creating a generic
class is to write after the name of the
class oh just to a less than and greater
than sign okay and then open your square
brackets
now
in here then you define
your generic
names like the data types with usually
with single characters let's say that
what you want is a pair of any data type
let's call the first data type a
and the second data type b because
there's two values so let's call this
one a and this one b okay you would just
write them as we just say we say a and b
okay
so then in here you would say final
a
value one so you're telling the compiler
that okay whatever pair i'm creating
the first data type that i accept is a
and that should be placed here
and then we say okay then the b is the
second one
and then we create a constructor for
this okay
so how you would use this then is you
would say final and is pair
then you would say foo and bar okay
and then this is just like a simple it's
very similar than to pair of
strings that we wrote up there you see
it worked as well but now in this case
dart is smart enough to understand that
names is a pair of string and string
meaning that the two values that you
pass to this pair generic class were
actually then placed for you
magically inside the a and b templates
that you provided up here okay
so if in if in this case then you said
okay i have foo
and then i have the value of 20
then dart smart enough to understand
that oh now it's a pair of string and
integer
so
that's how you would use uh generics
basically so i mean there are so much to
talk about about generics and how
you can
uh basically utilize them in order to
create
very simple classes so that they're
so that they're reusing as much
capability or as much code as possible
without duplicating that code so
and talking about generics to be honest
with you it could be it's its own entire
course we could go on and on four five
six hours i could talk about generics so
just know that generics are created like
this you say class pair and then you
would say
your generic data types which then in
case
then in turn get placed inside the
definitions inside the class itself so
okay
um
all right now that we've talked about
generics um i believe that we could kind
of like wrap up this um
chapter where we talked a little bit
more about advanced topics in dart
extensions futures
async awaits streams the weight for
stream generators and
generics okay
now i'm actually really happy that we
went through chapter number seven which
is this chapter because up until this
point we've kind of been like preparing
ourselves for our launch
it's
it's now time that we put everything
that we've learned into practice
and actually start building our project
so i'm actually getting goosebumps
because it's such an important part of
this course that we've actually gone
through the basics we've talked about
dart we've talked about like some of the
basics of setting up the simulator etc
etc that it's with great pleasure that i
can say okay we've gone through that now
and all you need to do right now is just
to practice and what better way to
practice
than to put what you've learned um into
application by
writing
the
flutter project that we've been aiming
to do from the beginning so
without further ado let's then
prepare for the next chapter which is
chapter eight and in chapter eight we're
gonna talk about
uh project setup and then we're actually
gonna add some dependencies to our
project which we're gonna use
later okay so
let's aim for that and i'll see you in
the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter number
eight of the slatter course
in this chapter we're going to talk
about our basic
project setup in the previous chapters
up until this point to be honest with
you we've been just working with dart
and kind of like
um laying the foundation for learning
the programming language that actually
um
uh it fuels flutter so it's a
programming language that you're gonna
need to be quite comfortable with in
order to be able to write your flutter
applications so you're gonna learn more
and more about dart as we go on in this
course but it is very very good if you
can
look at the intro chapter and then just
kind of like follow along on the
chapters up until this point so that you
get the general idea of what dart is all
about and then how you can use it
at a very shallow level i mean i know
there's lots of material that i put out
on that but
we really didn't like go so deep in
every topic so i just wanted to give you
like a flavor and taste of
the different available options in dart
so
if you haven't watched those chapters
please just go ahead and skim skim over
them even if you're comfortable already
with dart
so
in this chapter we're going to talk
about the project setup and this is the
like one of the absolute most important
parts of setting up
um an application for flutter so if
you're
if you're thinking of maybe skipping um
over this chapter that's also okay if
you know what you're doing but if this
is the first time that you're setting up
a flutter project that then i think it's
really good if you can
follow along with this chapter
so i'm going to go now into um
let's do some setup here so what am i
going to do i'm going to bring my face
to the bottom right here so you can see
the entirety of the screen
and then i'm going to bring up the
caption for the next item that we're
going to talk about
and in here well we have a um
as you can see there is a command that
you can issue in the terminal to create
a new flosser project so
every flosser project has different
properties it has for instance a name
which is the entire like the name of the
entire project
um and also one of
the
main properties of flutter project is
identifier
now the identifier wouldn't be so
important had it not been that flutter
can actually deploy to ios and android
and an identifier for
an ios app and an android app is
actually
what defines that application as unique
as on the app store where ios ios users
and ipad os users can download
applications and on the um
play store where android users can
download
android apps so these identifiers are as
i mentioned in one of the previous
chapters are kind of like reverse domain
identifiers so it's kind of like if your
website is
foobar.com and your application is
called baz
then your reverse domain identifier for
your application will become dot
foobar.bass
so it's kind of like
you take your domain name and reverse it
so if foobar.com becomes com.fubar and
then you put dots after that and then
you put your actual application name
so these identifiers need to be unique
and by that i mean like
if a if a developer
on the ios app store or google play
store is already gone and registered
the reverse um basically that item
identifier.com.fubar.bass
for any of their applications so they
said okay here's my application called
image gallery but it has a completely
random identifier of com.foobar.pass
then you as a new developer even if you
want to do the same funky uh deployment
to the app store you can't register that
name anymore because because it is
already
taken so
think of the identifier of your project
as
what is gonna carry on from the start of
where you create your project all the
way through to
the app stores okay so
it is quite important that you actually
choose it wisely because if you don't do
that wisely from the absolute start
unfortunately you will have to do some
filling around in the future
to go and update that yourself so
um
so i would i would really suggest and
recommend here that you take a little
bit of um time to think about what that
identifier is going to be
what you prefer that identifier to be
and what you're comfortable with and
what for instance if you have a domain
name as a developer for
the app store and for google play store
so if you have a domain name already
registered on your name i suggest
strongly then that you use that and if
you have domain names personally and
domain names
selected as like a
and for your company then you need to
now know whether you're going to release
this application under your name
personally or if you're going to release
it on your company's name
so these all play a role but
without further ado let's just go and
create our project here and
um
i to be honest with you i personally
haven't really thought about whether i
want to release this application as a
private person or if i want to create it
under my company and i think
since my developer account is
at apple and at google is under
my company's name which is pixelity ab
in sweden then i'm actually going to use
that company's domain name which is
pixelity.se
because s is like the swedish domain
name just as code.uk is the
um british one for instance
so i think i will do that so let's go to
and open a new terminal let's go to
terminal um
i don't see my screen right now but i'm
just going to bring up a new terminal
window here
and bring it up so that you can also see
it um
and i'm gonna increase the size of the
text so it is clear what i'm typing okay
so let me go ahead and create a project
so i'm gonna go to my development um
folder where i have all my projects and
i'm gonna go to projects
flutter okay
and then as you can see is flutter
create
and then and then dash dash org as an
organization
and i'm going to see say se dot pixelity
now as i said my domain name is called
pixelity.sc but your org needs to be the
reverse of that okay so remember reverse
identifier so reverse domain identifier
so
then if your for instance organization
is
hello dot com then here you would have
to write com dot hello alright
so i'm gonna say s epixody but you
shouldn't do this so if you're following
along with this course please just
choose an identifier for your domain
that it makes sense to you and if you
don't have a domain if you if you're not
bothered by all of that if you're not
going to release your application to the
app store you don't even have to care
about this just put anything in here you
could just say
come um
making stuff up
if that's what you want so it's not a
big deal to be honest with you so just
go ahead and pick an identifier so
i'm going to say s epixody because
that's my reverse domain name
and then in here you have to write your
app application name
so
um
what should we call this application to
be honest with you i i mean i personally
haven't really
made up my mind what this application
should be called maybe we should call it
uh
my personal
notes
my personal notes or my notes
something like that
or
private notes
okay
all the private notes
or notes list i don't know not my notes
that would work
sd pixel in my notes yeah why not
and
let's just call it my notes then all
right
so
let's go ahead and do that flutter
create
and i can see i mean actually i'm very
grateful that we got that little
notification on top so let this do its
work
and um
it did its work and it's done and it
called something and it created a folder
you can see called my notes
and on top of this window if you saw
then there was a little message printed
a new version of flutter is available to
update to the latest version just run
flatter upgrade so that was not a part
of this course i didn't mean it for this
to happen but i can't control it either
because flutter is a tool that is being
developed by google it's an open source
tool when there is a new version when
you run any of these flutter commands
and it's going to check
um with the version repository to see is
there any new version available and if
there is then it's going to give me this
flutter upgrade
message here so
um as i mentioned in the introduction of
the course
i've planned this course quite a lot but
i haven't i can't plan it 100 so things
will happen that i hadn't planned for
and then we just have to roll with the
punches and i'm actually glad that this
thing happened right here so you can see
how to upgrade flutter as well so
as you can see it's very easy just copy
just say flutter upgrade okay so i'm
going to go at the bottom of the
terminal i'm just going to say flutter
upgrade
right so this is going to actually take
some time depending on how big the
upgrade is because
flutter is divided into
different kind of engines as you know
flutter can output um
binaries or applications for ios it can
output it for android it can do it for
mac os it can do it for
um
windows
and basically desktop searches and mac
windows linux and then you will have web
as well so there's
quite a lot of things involved in
flutter as you can see in here it's like
downloading everything necessary in
order for you to be able to create
android applications so
so after that is done you see it goes to
the ios tool so it's downloading but
it's also i believe after it's done
downloading stuff
it also needs to make sure that it can
build those tool sets so
this is a process that might take some
time
and in order to avoid us having to wait
for that entire process
as you can see it's now going to web sdk
and blah blah
so we don't have to necessarily wait for
this so i'm just going to create a new
oh it actually finished so that was
quite fast all right so it it finishes
work we don't have to do anything
special here
um so that's how you upgrade flutter so
just run this command as suggested by
the flutter tools itself flat upgrade
and then you're good to go
okay so
we've done that step now so we've set up
our project i'm just gonna move to my
notes here
and i'm gonna make sure that that topic
is ticked
and for the next item what we're gonna
do here is we're gonna talk about um
we're gonna basically have a quick look
around the
the environment set up by flutter when
you run photo create because the flow to
create doesn't just like create an empty
director it actually creates the
skeleton or the scaffold of your
flosser project but pretty much
everything necessary for you to be able
to run that project okay
so in this in this application i mean in
this in this step of chapter 8 we're not
actually going to run the application on
any device that's for chapter 9 and for
chapter 10.
but what we are going to do is to have a
quick look around the
project structure so let me go to my
notes here and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to use this
code visual studio code
extension which is provided in the path
so i can just say code dot which opens
up visual studio code in the current
folder okay
so
then once that is done i'm going to
bring a visual studio code here i'm just
going to take a little bit of care to
ensure that you can see the
important parts of the screen
okay and i'm going to increase the size
quite dramatically so it's visible for
you as well it is very big on my screen
but i think it's like
a nice size on the on the actual output
video
alright so as you can see here is the
folder created by flutter create
and there are quite a lot of bits and
pieces in here
and i'm just going to
tell you
a bit about a few of these folders and
what they they represent so
one thing that you need to understand
about flutter is that it actually is not
like um
it's not really like react native
uh if you're familiar with that flutter
on ios for instance it for those who
have done ios development uh flutter it
outputs a native binary on your on your
phone
a native um
fat binary basically for your uh
ios application and it just puts one
view on the screen and then it
graphically renders all its contents
using metal okay so if you're not an ios
developer that probably doesn't make so
much sense to you but
this part that i'm going to mention now
should make sense for everybody but
when you create a flutter application
and the flutter create command basically
spits out different parts that may be
necessary for your application to run on
different platforms
one of those platforms one of the key
platforms that flutter runs on is ioso
that is the folder that contains the
native bits and pieces necessary for
photos to be able to run
in an ios simulator or on an ios device
such as an iphone or an ipad okay
so this is like as you can see it's the
project or the workspace and sorry and
the workspace because for those of you
who are ios developers you will know
that
there's a thing called cocoapods and
flutter internally actually uses
cocoapods for ios if you're not an ios
developer just know that
every
ios or android or web application
can bring with itself dependencies and a
dependency is a way for your application
to bring in code from other people in
order to be able to achieve special
functionalities so
there are various tools available for
ios developers android developers
web developers to be able to bring in
dependencies for web for instance if
you're writing a node application you
will just use npm which is a node
package manager if you're using swift
you will probably just bring in for
instance spm i think um swift package
manager or cocoapods
and there's another a third one
um which i've kind of forgotten the name
of um
which i may remember later if you're
using android you're probably familiar
with gradle and that you can like use
for
bringing in external dependencies so
so
if
this is a platform of android and this
is a platform of ios and here's web and
here's um
desktop for instance
flutter sits on top of these so it can
control all the um
all the small bits and pieces for these
platforms to be able to be packed
packaged inside one flutter application
which sits on on top here
and all these different platforms down
here
excuse me they can have their own
dependency management so the dependency
managements kind of sit under one layer
under so
flutter then talks with these dependency
managers and says okay you need to
install this dependency for me to be
able to work
so
the reason i mention all of that is
that is the reason you can see a
workspace here and an xcode project and
that's because flutter internally is
using a dependency manager
system called
cocoapods which in turn creates a
workspace
that
links together the main project and all
its dependencies
if you're not an ios developer if you're
not interested in all of this just know
that this ios folder
is just so that your application run can
run on an ios device
um
so that's that
the next part which is important is the
test folder which we're actually going
to use in this course
the test folder is where you create your
tests
if you're not familiar with software
development from before if you don't
have a background software engineering
testing is
the ability for programmers in order to
be able to make certain assertions about
their code and in order in order to make
sure that they can automatically run a
series of tests against their own code
to make sure that everything is
functioning as the programmer intended
that to if you are if you if you are
coming from software engineering
background that know that we're gonna
put our integration tests we're gonna
put our
widget tests and unit tests inside this
test folder okay so i hope that covered
everybody that's that may be watching
this course
then you also have a folder called
android and this is as you would expect
it is putting all the necessary files
and folders that is required for your
android project to be
hosting your flutter application so
just know that flutter kind of
is a series of tools is like a mobile
kind it's like a beautiful sdk
that gets injected into these native
applications and natively also renders
its content so
um
and just like we had a host ios
application here you will also have an
android folder which contains all the
bits and pieces required
for your application to be run natively
on
android
phones and on android tablets
so
this is as you can if you're an android
developer you're probably like already
familiar with this like you have your
app and build great gradle inside the
app folder so there's nothing like fancy
going on here it's a simple android
application which you can actually
uh if you have android studio installed
on your computer if you want to you can
open that folder and actually have a
look around and even run that
application as a native and android app
on your phone
okay
so
that is our android folder and as you
would guess then we have a web folder
because
i think i mentioned this before but
flutter supports uh deployment of flash
applications to the web as well so you
can actually create web applications
with flutter it's nothing that we're
going to discuss in this course
particularly but if you're interested in
writing web applications with flutter
you can also google that
so have a look at that if you're
interested in web applications because
though web applications in flutter are
relatively new but foster has actually
come really far with with that so people
are creating all sorts of websites with
flutter already
sorry about that
okay um then we have a little file here
called analysis options
and um as you can see it says this file
configures the analyzer so
um
if you are not coming from a software
engineering background then you may not
know what analysis actually means but
think of analysis as
a way for a flutter to be able to
have a look at the code that you write
and
and correct you
where it
sees fit so where it sees that oh you've
made a mistake in writing something that
could be written in a better way then it
consults this analysis options yaml file
and then it says okay what are the rules
that i have to adhere to like do you
want me to be very strict about certain
rules or do you want me to be like less
strict about other rules or do you want
me to completely ignore
certain mistakes that you're making so
the analysis options yaml file as it is
pronounced
it allows you to
basically define the roles that make
sense for your project
in this course we're not going to talk
about so much analysis options to be
honest with you but just know that it's
there
so let me bring up the uh
the project structure here again
um and the next thing that we need to
have a look at which is very very
important is this file pop spec dot yaml
now um this is a file that i mean
one of the things that you you'll need
to know about flutter and the basic
structure that it creates for you is
that there are tons of documentations
and documentations are like so so well
done in my opinion in in the flutter
world where i personally come from like
the back-end developer development
background like i'm doing django or
where i'm doing ios development
sometimes documentation can for instance
on the ios native world be very kind of
lacking
so
flutter has gone like well above the
line of what is required from a
developer's perspective in terms of
documentation and they provide a lot of
documentation
and if you're not coming from a software
development background the documentation
is pretty much like
information provided by the developers
who created the tool for you in order to
help you get better at that tool okay as
you can see here there's a file created
for you pop special and you can see
there's lots of gray lines here prefixed
with this
hashtag
if you remove them you'll see that they
become normal sentences but if you put
them back they become something called a
documentation and a documentation if
you're not from software engineering
background it means just piece of text
provided as an information block to you
which is not code anymore so the program
is not going to
turn this into any sort of sort of a
code it's just going to ignore that this
is just for you to learn okay
so let's go back to this pop specky ammo
and talk about what it actually is pop
spec yaml is such an important part of
flutter that i think that you need to
actually
ignore i mean don't ignore the comments
go and spend some time and read the
comments just to understand what they
mean
so
um what i'm going to talk about here is
a little bit about what this pop spike
yaml actually is it is if you're for
instance from coming from a web
background and if you've worked with
node.js then we will have some sort of a
config
json file or if you're coming from
django you'll have settings.pi file if
you're coming from native ios world what
would be the equivalent of the config
it kind of will be kind of like your
info plus file um
so
i mean it is your it is kind of like a
control panel of
what your project should actually be
looking like its icons the version
number its name all your dependencies so
these things will be all placed inside
inside this file and
when you change this file if you're
already running your application then
flutter are automatically
understands changes to this file and
then reconfigures itself if it can on
the fly
with your new configurations if it can't
then you may have to restart your
application like if you make drastic
changes for instance if you bring in a
completely new dependency
into your project
then the project cannot be like re-run
immediately it needs to actually
recompile and link against that
dependency it's just like humanly
impossible
or computerly impossible for it to do so
um
so let's have a little look around in
this pop specky ammo file as you can see
there's a tag here called name and it's
and it's a value it's my notes and if
you remember
from the terminal if i bring back the
terminal
bring up the text a little bit
uh this is what we created right this is
the project this is how we created the
project so
we said flutter creates an organization
of seda pixelity and then my notes all
right
that is what the my notes is for this is
your project name my notes all right
and this is a little just a little
description of what this application is
all about now
you may be
curious about what word is actually went
s e se.pixelity or whatever you created
your
project organization under
now you can see i search for it i said
command f in visual studio code on in
mac or control f in linux and
windows and visual studio code and i
don't know actually what the shortcut
for that fine is in uh
android studio i just now heard studios
a little bit peculiar about its uh key
mappings so it may not be command f on
mac or controller for linux and windows
so i search here now for sepixology and
you can see that there are no results so
this particular thing that i stressed so
much in the beginning that is very
important you choose wisely
is not actually something that flutter
itself needs as i mentioned it is
something that the different platforms
that you'll deploy to need so if i now
actually say command shift f in visual
studio code which searches in the entire
project say se.pixolity you will see
that it is found in different places
inside this project for ios for instance
you can see here is in the project pbx
approach
and for android as well in our build
gradle so you'll see the application id
became se pixelity my nodes
and for ios if you look around here as
well you'll see that it is s e pixel in
my notes okay
so
that was just side note um
so the other thing that you'll need to
know about the pop spec yaml is this
version number here and this is the
if you're not from a software
development background um if you haven't
done software development before
versioning is a way for you to tell
various places that you publish your
application on for such as ios app store
or google play store
what
if you have something new in your
application
so for instance if you and this is this
is how software is actually actually
labeled like a software has different
properties
what you're deploying what you're
developing here is a fluster application
but from the point of a store such as
the app store it's it's just a package
of stuff
with some properties like its name
identifier and its version now this
version is very important because it is
a number usually three digits
or i know that google play store
actually supports also four digits
separated by a dot
and these
these numbers actually mean something
special they
if you begin from the left and then you
go to the middle and then to the right
the left number is something called a
major number
the middle number is called a minor
number and the right one and then most
the rightmost number is usually called
the build number
in normal software development the
process is kind of like this that
you begin with an idea you say okay my
idea is to create a notes application
that's that's the first idea that's idea
number one then you put one as the major
number then you begin by zero and zero
okay so that's how a version number is
kind of like birth
so you say one zero zero that's version
one usually called okay
then you release that application you
say okay i'm fine with that version one
and then you're in the kitchen cooking
some food and then you say okay um it
would be great if i could put like um if
i could add
the ability for users to be able to
delete their notes
it's not a huge functionality it's just
a little bit um improvement on what i
already have in the store
then you will go and say okay is that a
major idea or a minor idea
hmm it's not a major idea a major idea
would be like a total rewrite of the
application adding massive number of
features fixing massive number of bugs
etc so it's not a major idea then you go
to the minor idea and that minor idea
corresponds to this minor version here
so you say okay the previous one was
zero this one is how big of a difference
hmm it's just a small future so let's
just say one
it was a huge like uh
minor idea
not major enough to be a major idea but
minor
but quite a big minor idea then you
would probably like
from zero to maybe two or three it's not
so popular to do that usually
would go chronologically in that order
like one two three four but you're also
welcome to jump versions
um
in special cases so let's say then you
say okay i fixed that
and i'll now make it build and send it
to
apple and google
just remember that your previous build
was build zero
now
depending on how your project is
structured like you may decide that okay
every build that i make i'm going to
actually increase this build number so
the previous one was zero now it's gonna
be one then it's going to be two three
four five six blocks so every time you
make build and send it out to your
consumers even if they're a group of
testers or
people who are
your only consumers may actually just be
people who are downloading your
application directly from the app store
or google play store
or from the web they may be interacting
with your application as well
then you may say okay every time i make
a new bill and send it out that's when i
actually increase this build number
or depending on your project setup you
may
come with into an agreement with your
teammates to say okay we don't increase
the bills chronologically but every time
we change the major or the minor we
actually reset the build back to zero
and then we go up chronologically so
um
i i don't want to go to be honest with
you too much into detail about the
version but if you're
interested in software development and i
think if you're watching this course
that kind of means that you're
interested in software development
you'll need to know about this so just
know that version is your way of
labeling your software and its features
and what's new in it
with numbers okay
so just remember major
uh minor build all right
but you don't have to play with this so
much to be honest with you so i think in
this entire course we're actually not
gonna play with it
so all right
uh the next bit of information in the
pop special is the environment as you
can see there it says sdk
now when you see sdk just think of
software development kit
and this sdk is referring to the flutter
sdk so it means that
if you share your source code with some
other developer who's sitting maybe on
the other side of the planet
if they get your source code and they
want to for instance be able to test
this application on a simulator or an
emulator on a real device then they are
required to have flutter sdk
version this
or less than this all right so you can
actually get your flutter version by i
believe if you run flutter dash dash
version
it will tell you that i'm plotter 281
and that as you can see here it says
yeah the sdk required in order to run
this application is two
one five zero more than or equal to that
at least at least two one five zero okay
so that's your sdk the flutter sdk
the other part that you'll need to know
about is this section in the pops wiki
ammo and that that is called the
dependencies and this is what we're
going to talk about actually
um
right now
and dependencies as i mentioned before
uh are ways for you as a software
developer to bring in code that other
people have written in order to make
your application application function
better or function in a completely new
way for instance
um you need to kind of be careful with
dependencies just because
depending on what dependencies or
libraries you bring into your project it
can actually make your life better or
worse
dependencies are
um
basically when you bring it in a
dependency they're usually code written
by somebody else or other people that
may be working on a library so
when you're if you're not coming from
software development background then you
will need to know this and i'm just
going to warn you from from now so that
you've heard it at least from somebody
dependencies when you're picking
dependencies just be a little bit
careful in that
they may
it may be that they initially make your
suffer better
but
since dependencies are code written by
other people
and other people's priorities change
their lives may change so that they
don't have time enough enough time to
continue working on those dependencies
so
i have personally run into the issue
that uh we brought in a dependency into
a project and then after a while we just
realized that oh
the developer isn't uh
actively working on this and maybe even
the developer made that library um
deprecated and deprecated is the world
that a word that you'll get to know when
you work more with software development
and deprecated kind of means that the
library is not supported anymore the
library is not
is not actively being worked on anymore
and the developers are encouraging you
to move away from them
so
when you bring in dependencies what i'd
like you to do is just to have a look at
who is behind the dependency
and prioritize your picking and cherry
picking
based on a few factors
if the divi if the
if the dependency is written by a single
person
um be a little bit careful about that
just because single persons
priorities may change and they may not
be able to
like continuously work on a
even if if it's an open source project
they may not be able to continuously
work on that
um if independence is written by an
organization especially an organization
that you have a lot of
faith in then prioritize it a little bit
higher
um
at least that's my opinion
if a dependency is written by a bunch of
independent people
under an organization prioritize that
also higher than a single person who has
a
who has a library under their private
name okay
that doesn't necessarily always mean
that a dependency created by an
organization is actually better quality
it just means that the chances of it
being deprecated are a little bit less
than
uh
chances of the same library being
deprecated had it been written by a
single person under their private name
so these may actually to be honest with
you sound a little bit high level at the
moment
and you may
think okay why do i have to need all
this it's just that it is very easy for
newcomers to flutter to get
dependent on dependencies in that it's
so easy to bring in a dependency and
just work with it that people forget
that oh
this is actually code written by a
single person sitting in there in their
room just like me sitting here and
telling you not to listen to people who
are sitting in their rooms
but i believe it is very important to
try to steer
your thoughts towards a little bit more
constructive dependencies that are good
for your project in the long run but if
you're writing an application i just
want to release it and don't care about
it anymore
after you've released it maybe
maybe it's okay to bring in a dependency
from just a
that that dependency that you don't even
care about but i would even challenge
that idea of releasing an application
which you may not care about after the
first release but because that's usually
not a good idea
okay a lot of talk about dependencies
but i think that had to be said
so we're talking about dependency i'm
just gonna bring in the captions so
um
now here you can also see there is a
dependency dependency here by default
brought into you by flutter itself
called cupertino icons
and cupertino icons is a dependency that
i believe that the flutter team itself
is actually behind
so
you may be thinking okay what are these
dependencies like where do they come
from they actually come from normal
people and
companies so i'm going to bring up a
um website here for you
and it is called pop.dev i'll bring it
up so that you can actually see it
here and um
you can see that in this website popped
up there you can search for dependencies
so i'm actually going to copy this
cupertino icons from here
and i'm going to paste it right there
um kupertino icon just enter and i'm
gonna press on it and you'll see that
it's published by the flutter team
themselves okay
so
pop.dev is the website where you will
search for dependencies so you just
search for a package and then it will
bring up results here for you so
um this is how you'll search for
dependencies okay
um
and
now that we talked about that let's also
talk about something called dev
dependencies
they have dependencies are
dependencies that will bring into your
project
which are useful only under development
so
if you're familiar with software
engineering the normal dependencies will
get linked to your project and then you
will they will be shipped with your
application whereas dev dependencies
there are only dependencies that
you
under the development time will use in
order to make your software better and
as you can see here one of the
dependencies for instance is flutter
test
or flutter lens in this case as well
excuse me
okay so there are lots and lots of
things to talk about here and as you can
see here in the future actually we'll
work with this that you can bring in
assets and images and bringing them into
your project okay
so
this is a quick look around at the pub
spec yaml and i'm going to
let this be here
i'm just going to tick in my notes here
that pops back yaml we've talked about
it
now to the important part
we actually in our application we're
going to need some dependencies in order
to be able to continue working with the
application now
we haven't talked so much about firebase
before but just know that firebase is
a tool that allows you to
kind of go serverless but also have a
server now serverless is just a fun
funky word that is being used nowadays
to describe a server written by somebody
else so a server that you don't
personally have to write if you don't
come from a software development
background for instance you're a product
owner or a designer
a server is where your data sits in the
cloud kind of
so
you as a developer sitting in front of
your computer right now you're writing a
flutter application and your flash
application is going to be installed on
ios and android devices and that is the
client the client is the consumer of the
data sent by the server okay so the
server is where the logic sits on a
computer in the cloud okay and firebase
is a computer in the cloud just think of
think of that that is written by google
so you control it with simple commands
on your computer but it controls your
data so your client your flutter
application can connect to it and grab
the data and read the data and
manipulate the data on the client side
so
now in order to talk to firebase we
actually need some um
dependencies and firebase um will i'll
bring up my safari window here
now let's have a look at firebase core
i'm going to search for it
click on it firebase core as you can see
it's written by the publisher is
firebase.google.com
and just remember that flutter is
actually a tool created by
google as well so
i personally think that anything related
to firebase is completely okay to bring
in into your flutter application has a
dependency all right
so
um i'm going to go here and then say
we need four dependencies
for this particular project okay so
if you're in visual studio code you can
bring um
the terminal up uh i actually forgot the
command for bringing the terminal i
think on my mac is control backtick
but i believe you can also always bring
up terminal advice going to terminal and
new terminal okay now i can see there
are two terminal windows here okay now
i'm going to get rid of the explorer on
the left hand side so you can see that
the data a little bit better here
there are four dependencies that we need
to bring into our project all right and
i want you to follow along with this
exactly as i'm doing
previously what we had to do in order to
i mean previously in the previous
versions of flutter if you wanted to
bring in a dependency then you'd have to
go and say
you go to your in your pop spec and then
add your dependencies manually with
special versions and then
you have to go to those dependencies top
dev websites to see the current version
all
but with the latest versions of flutter
you don't have to do that all you have
to do is just to say flutter pop add
and
i'm going to do that right now
so that's how you bring in a dependency
all right
the first dependency that we need is
firebase core so just enter this command
it'll take some time perhaps
okay
then say the same command but say
firebase
off i'm gonna have a look at my notes
basically here to make sure that i'm
entering the correct dependencies
and i'm not going to talk so much right
now about what these dependencies
actually are
because that is going to take a lot of
time as well so let's just bring the
dependencies in there are four
dependencies so the next dependency that
we have to bring in is cloud
firestore
and
let's go to the next one
and we say that
cloud firestore is the third dependency
and then we say firebase analytics
so that is the fourth dependency
so
we've brought in four dependencies at
the moment if you look here
there is a firebase core
which is like the
the kernel the main important parts
parts of firebase which again is what
we're going to use as our server where
all the nodes for all our users are
going to sit
the next one is firebase auth
auth is the short form let me see where
did it go um here firebase off that is
for authentication
and
um i haven't yet shown how that our
application is actually going to look
like but auth is for
authentication is where our users will
be able to register
uh log into our application and log out
and also get email confirmations to send
to their emails in order to be able to
verify the account so
auth is for authentication and that's
what we're gonna use it for in order to
make sure that people who
are interacting with our application
they're actually logged in okay
the next part is cloud firestore
and this dependency is used for when we
actually store a logged in users notes
in the firebase backend
all right
it's just funky names to be honest with
you they're just names decided
by developers just like me and you so
and the next part is firebase analytics
and that is for
if you use firebase analytics when you
basically set up your firebase backend
you will get some free analytics in for
instance oh which
screen did the user go to which button
did they press and you can have a look
at these analytics when you then look at
your firebase console which we're gonna
talk about later
i mean i know all of these are quiet um
maybe a high level if you're not if
you're not familiar with firebase you
may be like what the hell did we just do
and that is okay you don't have to know
all of this just know that we are these
four dependencies are stuff we need in
order to make our application function
all right so now that we've added these
dependencies you can actually go back to
your popspakiano file and kind of have a
look here
at the dependencies that we added and
you can see all of them were added here
automatically for you with their latest
versions okay so previously in previous
versions of flutter we had to do this
manually but now you can just say
flutter pop ad and it will add the
dependencies for you directly to pop
special all right
so
great a lot of things we discussed here
it almost took 50 minutes to go through
all of these basics but i believe
actually basics should take more time to
explain than the more advanced stuff
because
the more advanced you get the less
explanation you need so that is why all
these basic things basically take time
to explain
[Music]
okay
i'm just going to take in my notes that
we've talked about all of these
topics
and i think this is actually a wrap for
chapter number eight so chapter number
eight we talked about um
how to set up our project we've actually
set up our project now we've set up our
dependencies had a look around uh the
default flutter template and we also
talked about pop special so
that's great stuff in chapter number
nine we're gonna talk about my favorite
which is the ios app setup and in this
chapter actually we're gonna go through
a lot of things profiles certificates
we're gonna talk about app ids
a lot a lot a lot i can see here in the
list so i'm really excited actually for
chapter number nine
so
go grab a cup of coffee or a cup of tea
and i'll see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter nine of
this course
in this chapter we're going to talk
about the setup of our ios app and as i
mentioned it i think it was in um the
introduction
uh chapter in the absolute first
actually it's not a chapter it's just
introduction to this whole course
um we talked a little bit about what
we're planning to do with this
application that we're developing here
and um two of the things that we're
going to do is to actually release the
app in the app store and in the play
store now if you're not planning to
actually do that you could
potentially skip over this chapter
um
but i still believe that if you're
planning on becoming a flutter developer
you need to know how these things work
because
being a flustered developer depending on
what kind of flutter developer that you
actually want to become
um with me assuming that you want to
become an actual flutter developer where
you can for instance work on different
applications and release them personally
or you can work in like a team con
concept uh and in the context of a team
where you
work with other developers inside a
company for instance in order to work on
their applications and release them than
in the app stores so
if you're if you fall into any of those
categories that you actually want to
release your application then i strongly
believe that you should know how to do
that yourself so
although you may be a part of a part of
a team of a huge organization where the
release process is its own like process
that you basically hand over your source
code to them and then they basically
build it and repair it and release it
but if you want to become like a
full-fledged flutter developer or a
mobile developer for that matter you'd
need to know
how to actually release your
applications okay
so in this chapter we're going to talk
about
releasing your app or actually we're
going to talk about preparing your
application for releasing in
app store later so
what you need to know
is how do you set up your flutter
application so that you can actually
build it
later and release it in the ios app
store okay
and if i bring up the next caption here
you'll see that
in order for you to be able to
build your application and then deploy
it in the app store you need an ios
developer account
and i talked about this previously um
that
how what a developer account is and that
you'd have to apply for it i think it
was in chapter one we talked about this
but if you've jumped over that chapter
you'd need to know that you have to
apply for a developer account at apple
and once granted that developer account
then you're going to be able to get
access to a portal portal called the
app store connect
app store connect is your portal for
managing your applications
and uploading to the app store
downloading some debug information etc
which i'm not going to go into so much
detail right now and it also has a side
note as a developer you will get access
something called i think the developer
portal or something like that i think
it's called
i believe so i think we just call it
developer portal or developer developer
site
so you'll get access to that and you'll
be able to manage things such as
certificates and profiles okay so
which we're going to talk about soon
actually so
let's say that you have your developer
account and if you don't have your
developer account then please just go
and search online for register developer
account or just watch the first chapter
i have to look at my notes actually here
and see if that's what we talked about
in chapter one
actually yeah i can see here chapter one
was titled developer accounts and in
that chapter we talked about how to
register for an ios developer again in
depth so please go and watch
chapter one if you haven't done that and
if you are planning to actually release
your application
in the ios app store
so
sorry about that
so now you know that you need the
developer account and it costs a little
bit of money i think it's about 99 so in
sweden it's about 990 swedish crowns
something like that or 1000 swedish
crowns almost
so um
now that we've talked about the
developer account let's talk about the
certificates and profiles because this
is the thing that trips up a lot of
mobile developers when they come to ios
development
um i mean i've been doing ios
development since late 2000 2007
when
there was pretty much no um
ios sdk as such it was like just a set
of tools and very little library support
because originally ios apps by steve
jobs definition were supposed to be web
applications and then
apple just transitioned to disbelief
that yeah we actually have to have
native applications so they released
some tools and xcode was there so you
could build some simple applications
with ios opengl es what's there so you
can build some games as well
but
how it started was that
apple wanted to make sure that the
applications that are developed can only
be distributed through the app store so
they said that okay
if i give vandal for instance a
developer account he shouldn't be able
to create his own app store because they
it's just a
i'm not going into the details of what
why they're doing that there's a whole
topic and what we could discuss like a
few days we could talk about that
whether it's a monopoly or not i don't
know so i'm not going to go into the
detail about that but what you need to
know that
is there is an app store the um
basically just called app store but you
could call ios app store mac apps or
whatever you want
and apple has control over that so it's
apple
who sits there and like controls the
measures that apps that are published on
the app store they're of a good quality
for instance okay so apple themselves
have a certificate now a certificate is
like a piece of paper uh just imagine a
piece of paper certificate that they
hold onto and they said okay whatever we
publish on the app store
um
it comes from us okay so every app on
the ios app store
comes actually from apple i don't mean
that the apple has written the app i
mean that apple has signed the app using
their certified that piece of paper okay
so
and then when the app gets downloaded to
your iphone your iphone actually checks
is this a
is this a trusted application where does
it come from so
ios as an operating system it can
contain and you can install many
different types of applications that
come from many different types of
sources
such as
the ios app store or you could actually
download application that comes directly
from a specific developer
now
all these applications need to be signed
they need to be signed with a
certificate that is just to identify
where they come from so certificate is a
piece of paper that you as a developer
hold and every application
excuse me every application that you
develop will be signed using that
certificate okay so that certificate is
your identity as a developer and it gets
kind of
carried around in with your application
to the destination so if you develop
this notes application that we're doing
in this course and you sign it with your
certificate then your application is
going to have that certificate signature
inside it so when i send it to apple and
then apple is like aha that's this
developer who created this app okay
and then when apple then
says okay your application's fine you
can't release it to the app store then
apple re-signs your application with
their own certificate
that is just to make sure that your
application after it's been signed with
apple certificate can be distributed
into the ios app store and downloaded by
millions of users around the world so
it's just sir just know that certificate
is your identity as a developer okay
[Music]
now now that we talked about
certificates let's talk about profiles
because that also is a tripping point
for some developers
um especially if they don't come from
like a native ios development background
which i do
um
profiles
you see a certificate identifies you
in short profiles identify your app
so that's like the
very short way of saying it so you as a
developer might have
10 20 30 applications that you're
developing or you have developed
each of these applications will have
their own identity
and that identity at the end is tied to
you as a developer so you say here's my
certificate here's
who i am
but when you then create an application
then that application also needs to
identify itself it will be like here i
am i am an application signed with this
profile using this certificate so
just know that a profile is kind of like
an identity for your application
and different flavors of that
application
and a certificate is an identity of you
as the person who developed that
application all right
so
and if you notice i just said different
flavors of your application
and by that i mean that if you're not
coming from a development background
um if you're for instance coming from a
design background and you have a figma
file or visio file that you're designing
your wi-frames and whatever if you're
coming from a product owner ownership
background than your probably may have
like um
working with jira or excel sheets or
whatever wherever you put your
requirements you may not be familiar
with different flavors of an application
but if you've
worked a little bit close with an app
team then you'll know that there are
different flavors of every application
and
those flavors are usually i mean they're
usually two flavors
one is a development flavor and the
other one is a production flavor a
development flavor is the application
you see if you sit with developers with
software engineers that are working on
your application
on a daily basis they're coding they're
fixing things they're fixing bugs adding
new features and then they will provide
the product to you as a software uh as a
product owner for instance or a designer
and you will download that flavor on
your application and be like okay this
this looks fine great
now
all of a sudden you press a button and
that button crashes the application so
the application just disappears oh
it crashed
well at that point if the developers
were doing their job correctly then they
had had to put some crash analytics into
the application
that
as soon as the application crashes or
something bad happens to the application
of that flavor of the application that
you
installed on your
iphone or android phone or
tablet or whatever and they will get
something called a crash report
a crash report is as its name indicates
it's just a report where the crash
information is completely visible and
they probably even know which button you
tapped at what time and what was the
information
that your app was carrying at the point
that it crashed so it helps them
debug and fix that problem
now these flavors of the application
that you install on your phone on a
daily basis were working mobile
developers are usually called debug
applications and a debug application
it's just a way of saying that the
developers who created it it created the
application have the opportunity then to
fix any bugs that may arise with more
information than they would usually have
had they released this application to
the store for millions of
others to download so
that is a flavor it's a debug flavor or
is a development flavor okay and it just
means that it's a daily it's kind of
like a
updating regularly application that only
very close circle of people close to the
project can download so that's a flavor
okay
another flavor of an application that
gets released by developers could be the
production
flavor and the product production flavor
is
the same as the debug flavor but
a little bit like
some stuff maybe removed from it some
sensitive information that may be logged
otherwise maybe removed from it it's
just like a stripped-down version
for security purposes not stripped-down
version of like features or anything
it's just
they make it tighter they make it so
that it is a little bit more secure like
some extra stuff may be removed from it
extra stuff that otherwise developers
only may need so
when it then gets packaged into this
beautiful little uh
yeah beautiful little package basically
then it will also be a new flavor called
the production flavor
so now you have two flavors one is like
for a close circle people sitting next
to the product
in the same product
room or now that everyone's working
remotely maybe people are sitting at
home etc and that is like the product
team closely developers testers product
owners designers uxers everyone that is
the closed circle
they get the development builds usually
and then when you get to
sending your application to apple for
instance
or to google for review then you would
get the production flavor okay the
reason i'm talking about flavors is that
these different flavors on ios at least
are basically
assigned with their own specific
profiles so then you'd have a
development profile and you would have a
production profile and these prof
profiles dictate to your application
what it what it can and it can't do
for instance one of the capabilities of
a development profile in the ios world
is that your application can actually be
installed on a telephone hooked with a
cable or even
without a cable and debugged remotely so
this is one of the cool things you can
do with ios in that you can actually
like if i'm a developer sitting here
i can
get the designer's telephone and say oh
yeah you want the application like do
you want to actually see what i'm
working on yeah she or he would say
you would
connect your their phone to your
computer and enable something called
remote debugging
and then you would disconnect it and
then give the phone back to them and
whenever they want the application
running live on their phone as you're
developing it you can actually run the
application with your xcode
live under
uh iphone or ipad so
that is its own flavor and the profile
which is the development profile
dictates to that application that you
can be debugged but if you then want to
sign your application with a production
profile and send it to apple
that profile dictates that this
application is not allowed to be
debugged
and when you
create your application and send it to
apple you need to make sure of two
things
among many other things but
certificate and profile wise you need to
make sure of two things
the application is signed with your
production certificate and the
application is signed also with the
production profile which is hooked to
the production certificate so first the
certificate should be there using the
certificate you create the profile with
the profile you sign your application
and then you send this application to
apple apple then looks oh everything is
is in order
the profile to use was a
a production profile and the certificate
linked to the profile was also correct a
production certificate identifying you
as a developer
so
that was almost 16 minutes of
information about profiles and
certificates for ios but i think they're
so paramount
in i mean it's so important to
understand
that you shouldn't really jump over
these concepts as if you're if you want
to become a mobile developer it's so
important so
now enough with
concepts now let's talk a little bit
about
um
the developer account and here i
actually have a link which i'm going to
open in a separate window
and then i'm going to bring it to the
foreground so you can actually see
so here is the developer account as you
can see on apple's website and i'm gonna
bring my face a little bit to the right
bottom right so zoom into the window
here
and this is actually on developer
then you would go into accounts okay so
after you've registered an account
then you will be able to go in here and
sign in with your account and i'm going
to sign in with my
um companies apple id
there we go and then it says okay we
sent you a verification code and i have
my
apple watch here so i'm i'm just gonna
say i didn't get a code and text me the
code all right
so
in a short while i should be able to get
a verification code here
and it is important that you don't show
this verification code to other people
it's just you shouldn't do that so i'm
gonna remove the screen from where you
can see it and i'm gonna enter the code
that was sent to me it is six digits and
it is uh just basically digits and
bring the phone i bring the browser up
now and i say trust this browser okay
[Music]
so
here you will see that um license
agreement has been updated okay so we
should be able to review that later so
i'm gonna increase the
space that this screen is taking at the
moment so you can see it in its entirety
and you can see that now that you you've
logged into this account you should be
able to see things such as
overview membership people's
certificates ids and profiles okay
so and then what i talked about earlier
which is your app store connect okay
so um
and
what happens here basically is
that
in the membership people's certificates
ids and profiles is where you will
manage your certificates and all your
profiles as i mentioned before
so
um
here it is very important that you
basically set up a good ground for your
uh certificates create the dev
certificate the
the production survey and then you
create your profiles after that which
we're gonna talk actually about in this
um
in this chapter
so
here are the missing pieces for us in
order to be able to
carry on
so we need as i mentioned before
certificates profiles and app ids app id
is something that i didn't mention
before so i think it's just important
that i mention what an app id is
an app id is
additional to the profile that you
create an app id is an identifier that
apple and you use in order to know which
application you are
talking with
both you yourself and also
if you for instance in the in the future
are going to enable
features such as push notifications
now if you're not familiar with what
push notifications are they're basically
remote notifications remote information
that you can send from a cloud somewhere
on the internet
to a user's phone so when they get their
phone they will see oh here is a message
from this application
you can think of it as remote messages
just as if someone sent you an sms or an
imessage
or for instance if you're using whatsapp
or telegram someone writing a message in
a chat and then you're getting a
notification on your phone that is
called a push notification so
an app id is used mainly in order to
be able
in order for you as a developer to be
able to specify different capabilities
of your application for instance that it
can
receive push notifications that it can
for instance store secure information on
the phone etc etc so
so when i previously mentioned that you
need a certificate and profile in order
to sign your application you also need
an app id in order to identify your
application and its capabilities okay so
we're going to talk about that soon
actually
so
now
what we need to do here before we
actually get started creating a
certificate
uh is to
talk about the keychain now
if you're if you're if you have a
developer account here and you are
planning on releasing your application i
kind of can basically assume that you
have
a macintosh so that you have registered
for an account
and that you want to be able to sign
your application with a certificate and
profile
however you may be in a group of people
who doesn't have a
who doesn't have a macintosh and xcode
etc but you still want to be able to
release your application to the app
store so you may want to for instance
create your certificate profiles an app
id and then later send that information
to some sort of a cloud hosting service
for for them to sign your application
and then send it back to you something
like that i have never done that myself
but you may be in that group and uh
for the sake of being inclusive i think
it's important to talk about that
um now
let's talk about what i've put up here
as the caption and that is like the
certificates in the keychain
you see every
certificate gets created by you as a
developer sending a request to apple
now
this request is
you basically creating a digital
signature on your computer
which
your computer holds onto
then your request you will send it to
apple apple says oh you're asking for a
certificate okay here's the certificate
and then you download that certificate
and then when you double click on the
certificate it gets installed and hooked
to your original request okay so here's
the certificate and here's the private
key so
the private key is just a piece of
information that your computer stores
digitally on only your computer so that
later the downloaded certificate can
actually be hooked to it creating a
chain okay so
your application when it gets signed
with your certificate that you then
download from apple
it actually contains some information
about the certificate and the private
key and then you send the application
that was signed using these two pieces
of information to apple so
there's a lot of information i know but
i think it's important for every mobile
developer who wants to
release something for ios appstore to
know this um
now this
private key and the certificate they
both get stored inside a program on your
computer called keychain if you have
macintosh
and i can bring up keychain actually
now let me see which i have three
screens here so i don't know which one
is gonna get open on
so
i will bring up keychain here um
and i will show you how it looks like
so
here is an example of keychain and you
can see here there's a distribution
certificate and a development
certificate okay
and these certificates i didn't create
them i downloaded them but the things
under them this is the chain i was
talking about this is the key that i
created okay
so when you request a certificate from
apple you actually create this thing on
your computer and you upload this thing
to apple for them to create a
certificate hooked to that kind of not
you don't actually upload exactly this
but something that is related to this
okay
so
for us in order to be able to continue i
think it's important that i actually
delete these
existing certificates from my computer
so i'm just going to go like this and
i'm going to be like
delete two items all right and delete
them just like that
okay so now they're gone now what we
need to do is
um
here let me put up the captions so you
can see
so that was the certificates and now we
also need to talk about um
we also need to talk about actually
deleting the profiles now this is an
interesting part if you already have
like profiles installed on your computer
you may not want to do this but i'm just
going to show you this step so that we
start with a clean slate okay so you're
not supposed to do this if you exactly
know what you're doing with your
certificates but if if this is the first
time you're doing this and there may
already be some certificates for you on
your computer for some reason then this
is the way to actually get rid of them
so i'm gonna open up finder
um
let me open up finder here
and i'm gonna bring it up here
and what we need to do is to go into a
folder called um
i believe it's called library and then
mobile
device
and then something called provision
profiles okay
and you can see here um and i will show
you this path again so it's my user
library mobile device and then provision
profiles okay
so after i've gone into that folder i'm
going to delete these profiles that are
here okay
so you don't have to do this if you
don't want to and you know exactly what
you're doing but i'm just doing it to
show you that profiles are always stored
in that location for your user okay
and what you can also do which i really
like is to if you say add columns here
and kind of like drag it into your
favorites so you don't have to type that
path every time so let's just put it
here okay so that every time i want to
install the profile i can just click
here and put my profile there all right
all right um
now that we've done that the next step
as the caption shows here is to delete
our existing certificates and profiles
from apple's
development account so let's go to
certificates ids and profiles here on
the left hand side and you'll see here i
have quite a lot of things stored right
here okay you see distribution
development development blah blah
so what we can do here is to go ahead
and delete these certificates on the
left hand side you see it's a
certificate so there are quite a few of
them
so what i'm going to do is just to tap
on this one and just say revoke revoke
tap on the next one and just revoke them
one by one so and again if you're new to
ios development and you've just gotten
your development account you don't even
have any certificates so this screen is
going to be empty for you so revoke
revoke so your screen is gonna look like
this all right
so now that we don't have certificates
i'm also going to go into profiles and
delete these profiles so if i just go in
here and kind of like say all my
profiles and then just delete this is
going to be fine as well so sort of
problem all right so now i've deleted
all my profiles
and certificates
and that was the goal of this part of
the chapter
9 i believe so yeah
i've now deleted the existing
development and production certs
and
then that is done with the profiles as
well they're also gone
so what we need to do now is to create
something called a development
certificate and just to recap a
development certificate is
a certificate that will allow you as a
developer to run and test your
application
while you're developing it on real
iphone or ipad all right
so it's it's not necessary for releasing
the application but i personally after
many years of experience developing
mobile applications i've come to the
conclusion that i prefer actually
running my application testing my
applications are real devices as i
develop because you also have emulators
and you also have simulators that
simulate and emulate the capabilities of
iphone and
android phones or tablets but i've come
to the conclusion that it's actually for
me at least better to test my
application real phones or tablets
so in order to be able to do that and if
you have for instance an iphone
connected to your computer
um and you want to test your flag
application on that iphone then the
first thing you need to do is to create
a development certificate so you need to
identify yourself as a developer to
apple so let's go to the certificate
section and then just say create a
certificate and then choose apple
development actually sorry ios app
development
this is interesting it says
yeah so it says apple that's very
interesting so you can basically use
something called apple development but
we're not going to do that we're just
going to say ios app development at the
moment okay
so
let's do that just choose ios app
development and just press continue and
here it says create a new certificate
and create a new certificate is it's
waiting for you to tell it that you're
asking for a development certificate and
you need to choose a file now this is
the magic part you need to now go back
to
keychain so let me see if i can bring up
keychain again
and in here
just go to keychain access menu
and then say
a certificate assistant and then say
request a certificate from a certificate
authority okay
so i'm gonna press that and i'm gonna
put my company's email here
and the common name i'm just gonna leave
it as my name all right
and then i'm just going to say save to
disk
all right
so um
that's what we're doing now
then i'm gonna say continue and it says
okay i'm gonna write a file on your
desktop or wherever you want with that
request so save it somewhere that you
know where it is actually saved so i'm
gonna save that and then say done all
right now you see
that certificate request in itself
didn't create a certificate it's just a
certificate request but what it did is
that it created a private key
and you can actually go to your keys
here and you'll see that there was a
if i say kind private key so one of
these keys is the one that was just
created right now okay
i don't exactly know which one because
it doesn't have a date but it's just one
of these so every request for creating a
certificate
it creates with itself a private key
okay so keep that in mind let's go back
to my certificates
now that that file has been saved on
your desktop just say choose file and
then go to your desktop
and pick that certificate request okay
and it's you see here certificate
request search sign request
and just say continue
and then it says okay it expires in a
year and you need to keep that in mind
because development certificates do
always expire in a year and you need to
by basically renew them okay
so but for now you don't have to worry
about that because we're not going to
take a year to develop this application
so let's just say download and it got
downloaded to my downloads folder so
i'm gonna bring up my downloads folder
uh and actually
just
gonna show you here
like this
so
here is
the file that got downloaded you see
it's a cert file all right now this
certification in itself it doesn't
contain your private key remember the
private key is in the keychain so what
you need to do is just you need to
double click on this all right so
double clicking on it you see it will
then create a certificate in your
keychain under my certificates and login
keychain that is linked with your
private key you see so this is what you
downloaded from apple this is what you
created on your computer by requesting a
certificate and when you double click on
the downloaded certificate these two get
hooked together okay
so that's it that that is what you have
to do to create a development
certificate and the key related to it
all right
now let's go to the production
certificate and we need to kind of do
the same thing same process
in order to create our production
certificate so let's go back to all
certificates and i'm just going to say
plus certificate and
i'm gonna say ios distribution app store
and ad hoc okay so choose that option
please
and sorry i'm just gonna not also in my
notes here that we talked about the dev
certificate
so let's go ahead and press continue
here and you'll have to do the exact
same process as you did for the
development certificate and create a new
certificate request so
let's do the same thing just basically
kind of copy and paste the same process
go to keychain access
certificate assistant request a
certificate from a certificate authority
and just be careful a little bit with
this because i've understood from what
i've what i've seen is that depending on
what you've chosen here this menu
actually changes
so
it could be that you kind of need to
make sure in your keychain that you're
not selecting anything
so just make sure that nothing is
selected and then go to um sorry then go
to
certificate assistant and request a
certificate for certificate authority
put your
company's or your developer accounts
email there i'm just gonna pick solid a
b
and then save to disk and then say
continue
and then save it to desktop and since
there is a file already there with the
same name from the previous step it's
going to say are you sure you want to
replace it yes replace it
and it got saved then i'm going to go
here and then choose the same exact file
but it's
actually is a new file which got
rewritten
and then say continue
and you'll see now there is a download
so
i'm going to download that and if i go
to my downloads folder um
here i'll bring it up so you can see as
well
um
let's see
i'm going to bring it here you will see
that there is a new file called ios
distribution that is your production
certificate okay so double click on that
keychain it's open again and you'll see
now you have two certificates here
iphone distribution and then iphone
developer so
these are your certificates and keep
hold of them kind of like try to save
them and if even if you don't save them
it's okay because they're now placed
here so you can always export them okay
but it's also good practice just to keep
hold of them
great
now
sorry about that
now we've created a developer and a dis
and a production or distribution
certificate
let's talk about the next step and that
is required for us to be able to release
or test our application on
on phones so
let's go back here and to identifiers
and in here is where you create your
application identifiers and you can see
that they're actually tied to a specific
organization and identifier which we
talked about
in which chapter was it that we talked
about i think it was actually in chapter
eight
yes if you have if you don't know what
an identifier is please go back to
chapter number eight where i discussed
that so
let's
press the plus button here
and say that you want to create a new
app id okay press continue and then you
will choose app here not an app clip
and then you will be presented with this
screen here so i'm gonna
explain to you what all this is so
in here the description um we're just
gonna print some information here that
describes our application and to be
honest with you i don't remember what we
actually called our application when we
created
in the previous i can see it was called
my notes
so i'm just going to say my notes
flutter application sample or flutter
app all right
here the bundle identifier is very
important that you actually specify it
correctly as we created it in our
in chapter 8. so i'm going to bring up
the my notes application here i'm going
to increase the font size so you can see
um if you remember where we created the
application
with this command you see we said
se.pixelity and then my notes meaning
that the application identifier from
this point on is going to be
se.pixelity.mynotes okay with a dot in
between all right so if i search for
that in our project let's say
sepixolity.mynotes
you will see there are some results here
you see so depending on how you created
your floater application depending on
what organization you specified this
identifier may be different for you but
since my identifier in this case is s
epixody my notes i'm just gonna copy
that
and i'm going to bring it here make sure
explicit is selected and just paste that
bundle id in there okay so yeah it's
chosen
now if you remember what i said before
an app identifier is not just the
identifier the bundle id itself but it's
also like a list of capabilities that
your application can have now if you for
instance want to have push notifications
you will also need to enable that in
here now push notification is not not
something that we're going to do in this
course so you don't have to do that but
all you need to do here after you've
entered your app id prefix sorry your
app bundle an identifier and a
description just press continue
and you can see that says okay are you
sure everything's fine yeah explicit
yeah great and then i say register
now that identifier got created all
right
so
um
you don't really have to do anything
with that identifier right now it's just
that you have now registered that
identifier so no one else can basically
take that app from you
so
i'm gonna
actually
tick these items in my notes so that we
know we've talked about it all right
now the next step
is to prepare your
uh your application so that it can
actually be installed and debugged or
tested on real phone now
you can't see my entire setup but here i
have an iphone 12 pro which is just
right here it's a little bit dirty
screen but that doesn't matter it's just
my test telephone
and
this phone
is connected as you can see with a cable
to my computer and it is available for
my computer to see so i'm just going to
unlock this phone right now with my
passcode
and if i then bring up my
finder
so here
you can see that it is available here
right here okay
so it's my telephone and
it has a special identifier and if you
want to get your device identifier which
is what we need to do here as you can
see in order to debug on a real device
we need a uid to register for our
profile
so
when you i mean this is a kind of like a
big thing to talk about because it takes
a lot of time but what i'm going to say
here is that when you created that
development pro and development
certificate the next step is for you to
basically register your device with
apple so that apple knows on which
devices you actually want to test your
application all right
and those devices they're stored in here
in under the devices um tab
and there are ways to get your device
identifier such as going to finder as i
just showed here and just tapping on
your
device now i'm kind of going to do it
off screen so you don't see the entirety
of what is here
so
let me see if there's any way for you to
actually get your device identifier yes
and it is i can actually see here
there's a way to get that um
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
actually bring finder up here so you see
what happens i just tap on my phone now
you need to register your device on
identifier under this devices tab before
you create your profile okay
i'm not going to do that because my
phone is already registered but you need
to do this on your own and the way to do
that is to connect your phone or your
tablet which you want to test your
flutter application on to your computer
then
go into finder and tap on your phone and
then just click on this section now i'm
not going to do that here and the reason
behind that is that every device
says identifier really identifies that
device so you could go and register my
device under your account
so
and it's just not a good idea to show
your device identifier to others so i'm
not i'm not going to be able to do that
unfortunately in this course but
the steps you have to take is to click
here
on this label and it will show you a
section called uuid
copy that uuid and go into devices
section of the certificate identifiers
and profile section of apple developer
account and add that uuid with a name to
your account
okay so i'm just gonna assume you've
done that and if you need some time to
go ahead and do that please pause this
video and do that so
the key is just to get the identifier
from here okay there's a way also get
your identifier your device identifier
from xcode um and that works exactly the
same you just have to open xcode then go
to um i believe go into menu and then
pick devices and from there you pick
your device and you'll see it's
identifier right there
so that was a lot of talk let's say that
you've already done that
so what we need to do now is to go and
create a development profile all right
so i'm just going to tick these items in
my notes as well
so this is the exciting part now we're
going to go to the profile section and
create a new development profile so
click on generate a profile and i'm
going to say ios app development and
then say continue
then it says okay choose an app id you
see now your profile is going to be
linked with your app so
do this drop down here and you can see
i'm just going to say my notes and this
is the app that i created
and for you this id maybe a little bit
different the description maybe a little
different but just choose the
um
app id that you created in the previous
steps so i'm going to choose that i'm
just going to say continue
now it's going to say okay which
certificate is this profile connected to
do you remember i said that a profile is
linked to a certificate this is what
that actually means so
granted that you've created your
development certificate in as i talked
about in this chapter just select your
certificate so and then say continue
now
here it asks is that
which devices do you want this um
profile which which device do you want
your application which is signed with
this profile certainly to be able to run
on now these all these devices come from
the devices section i've registered many
devices so
um
even some of my co-workers devices
which allow us to basically debug an
application on their devices as well so
granted that you've
done that
if you go back here
then you will see those um
see those devices in this list
right so i'm just going to say select
all just make sure my application can be
run on all those devices that i've
registered okay
then say continue and then you will give
it a name so i'm going to give it a name
of my notes
dival dev
profile
or just my notes dev okay
i'm just going to say generate
and you will get some information about
when it expires etc also expires in a
year
so and then you'll have to say download
and we're going to do the exact same
thing now for a distribution profile a
distribution profile is the kind of like
the same dev profile but you cannot
debug your application with it all you
can pretty much do with it is to sign
your application with that profile and
send it to apple so that you can deploy
your application in the app store okay
so press plus profile and in this and
this time go to distribution and say app
store you see distribution subsection
and app store
so press the continue button
then go here and then choose your
application
so that was the development profile
sorry now we have to go to production so
i'm going to bring the window a little
bit up so that you can see it in its
entirety so
then i'm gonna choose my notes
all right
and then i'm just gonna press the
continue button here
um
i'm gonna take it in my notes so we've
talked about the dev profile okay
so now that you've done that uh
choose your assertive again you see it
says okay now you're creating a
certificate a profile for a distribution
then it should be hooked with some sort
of distribution certificate and since
ios distribution certificate is the only
one that we created if you remember i
deleted all my other certificates
so that's the only one left here just
pick that and press continue
now give it a name i'm going to say my
notes
prod
production
and then i'm just gonna say generate it
says
okay there you go and you can download
it all right
now that you've done that you need to
bring up your
downloads folder where your profiles got
downloaded um
now you see these are the two profiles i
got downloaded except with their
extension of mobile provision provision
you need to install these somehow on
your computer so that you can sign your
applications or your ios application
with this with these
so what you need to do now is to copy
these two files i'm going to copy them
like this and command c
and then bring them into your provision
profiles folder i'm just going to
cut and paste them there okay so they're
not in the downloads folder anymore so
there they are
there are other ways of installing these
profiles some people rather drag it into
xcode some people double click on them
and those are all fine but there's a
little bit of a problem by doing those
methods compared with the method i
showed you here if you double click
these profiles
mac os knows how how to install them but
mac os just messes up their naming so
they will be installed on their very
random names so if you come back to your
provisioning profiles folder they may be
under some sort of a cryptic name that
you don't recognize anymore so in this
way they
basically keep their original name which
is very descriptive of what they
actually are okay
okay that was that so now we've created
a um dev profile and a prod profile
exciting stuff so what we need to do now
is actually work we can say that we're
done with this screen here so i'm going
to close that
and what i'm going to do here then is to
what we need to talk about now is to set
up our project
in xcode so that xcode understands that
our application needs to be signed with
the correct profiles and certificates so
what i need you to do is to go to the
ios folder in your flutter project and
just right click on it and say reveal in
finder okay
after you do reveal in finder double
click on the workspace in order to open
your
flutter xcode workspace in xcode
and what you'll need to do now is to
basically
make sure that your signing of your ios
application is done correctly so choose
this icon on top left in your um i think
it's project explorer or something
project navigator
then on the targets
choose your targets and then go to
signing and capabilities and just remove
automatic signing okay
for this course we're not going to use
automatic signing
i'm just going to take it
here in my notes that i've talked about
removing automatic signing
so
the next step is for us to be able to
tell xcode that for debug purposes in
order for us to be able to run our
application
on a real phone and debug that
application which profile and which
certificate it needs to use
so what i'm going to do here is to go
into this section here as you can see
debug on under signing and capabilities
and then i can see that actually it is
going to
it's already using the automatic signing
for debug and i'm going to remove that
as well okay
so what you need what you need to do
here is actually pick the right profile
here
and it says my notes dev and my notes
profile sorry prod and you can see it
says ineligible
and um
that is because we don't have a
development team yet and alex and i'll
explain that soon but for now just go to
your provisioning profile and say for
debug purposes we're gonna use the
mynotes dev
um
and then go to your release and then say
i'm gonna use my notes prod okay and
here's a little error here you see it
says producing profile my notes pro
doesn't include signing certificate
apple development blah blah blah okay
that's that's fine don't worry about
that
so
what we need to do now is to actually
tell it um so i'm going to actually pick
here
profound search setup release profile
insert okay
so what you need to do here is to
go to your build settings and make sure
that your development
team
here is actually selected you see
pixelity is for me and then for you it
may be something else so
um now what i'm gonna do i mean
sometimes uh and i can see signing
certificate here is actually not really
selected sometimes it can be that xcode
kind of goes crazy when we play with
certificates and signings so i'm going
to close xcode
i'm going to do the same thing here go
to
revealingfinder
finder open up in another window here so
i'm going to open up the workspace again
okay i can see we're still getting the
problem provisioning profile minus that
doesn't include signing certificate
apple development and let's open up our
keychain again and have a look a little
bit here
and i can see unfortunately there is a
profile you can see previously we had
two profiles and it is very unfortunate
because um
so in here you can see this this
development
certificate was created by us you see
they're very tightly close to each other
these two we created but this is
something that xcode has created and
that is because xcode tries to do
automatic signing as you saw it was
saying automatically manage signing so
by doing that it created a certificate
for me on my behalf which i don't want
so the error that we're seeing here is
that
xcode is now saying that this this
profile that you have here is not linked
to this thing
which xcode created itself no one asked
it to do that i didn't ask xcode to do
that so when you're working with is a
woman just know that xco tries to do a
lot of magic for you and
if you want to actually
do things manually
it may get in the way
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to delete this
development certificate because i didn't
ask for it okay
so i'm going to say
i believe actually that's the right one
yeah so i'm going to say delete delete
and now you can see that error went away
simply because xcode was like ooh now i
understand which one you're talking
about
and then the provision profile of the
prod
also is hooked
correctly
so
now
what i'm gonna do is as you can see here
i've opened the project here and then i
have my actual iphone selected here to
be able to make sure that your
application can actually run on this
phone now after all of this hard work is
just to press the play button here
so i want to do that and i want to let
it do its thing and if everything works
correctly
um it's going to basically then um allow
us to run the application all right
so now it says
now and this is a dialogue that you're
probably also going to get
what's happening here is that it's
trying to sign the application and all
its libraries
using that profile
development profile and since that
development profile is
linked to a development certificate in
the keychain and that keychain is
password protected you see the login
keychain it says i can't access that
certificate give me the password for the
login keychain so i'm going to type that
and then i'm going to say always allow
so let's do it let it do its thing
and this may depending on the machine
that you're running this uh process on
it may take some time
i can see it's saying now building so um
okay then i got an actual failure here
it says cloud firestore wasn't found
and this is very interesting um
actually i mean i didn't plan for this
to happen but it did happen i'm kind of
glad that it happened
this happens usually
when you um
when you add new dependencies to your
projects such as these big dependencies
but they're not really linked to your
project yet so the way to fix that is
i'm gonna
let xcode be here okay i'm gonna close
this
i'm gonna bring a terminal uh what i'm
going to say here is flutter
clean i clean
ios
or clear ios i think clean
so this is basically going to clean up
how the ios project was set up and all
those dependencies all right now i'm
going to close actually xcode as well
then what i'm going to say is to say
flutter pop get
and flutter pop get what it does is that
it sets up all our dependencies from the
beginning and just to make sure i'm
going to go into the ios
folder and i'm going to say
pod install
and
could not be compatible version okay pod
[Music]
install
dash dash update repo
uh
hot install
uh let's see if we can do an update repo
i'm just gonna do that uh without like
explaining it right now so much and see
if that fixes our problem i'm going to
bring up a new safari window and say
pod install update repo let's see what
the command was but because i've
forgotten that
what update we have
yeah um let's pawn install
i believe
there is a variant of
repo update it's called okay pot install
repo update let's see if this fixes our
problem
and if cisco could not find compatible
version for podcloud firestore from blah
blah
specs satisfying from dependencies were
found but they require higher minimum
deployment target and that's very
interesting
so
what is happening here is
you see the deployment target that we
have for our application um what it
means is that
when we created the project with flutter
flutter said that
what it does internally is says
this flutter application should be run
on these ios versions and these android
versions and what we're seeing here
is that
what we're seeing here is that we are
using cloud firestore and cloud
firestore as a dependency is expecting
our application to have a minimum
deployment version it means that cloud
firestore cannot be used in applications
that for instance are trying to run on
ios 7 for instance okay so what we need
to do here in your um flutter project
just say command p in visual studio code
and open up a file called um
pod file all right
you go in there and
let's see
here we have some stuff set up let's go
in here and just say platform ios and
what we're going to do is just to say
platform ios 13
just just now i mean 13 it's really good
because right now is ios 15 is available
so you could just say you're supporting
15 14 and 13. so i'm going to do that
and then i'm going to run pod install
again
and this time i can see that things are
going a lot better and it's installing
all our dependencies without a problem
so
um what you need to know now what i did
here was something that you probably
would need to do if you're comfortable
with ios development so you need to fix
these problems by hand
but before i explain what i actually did
you need to know about something called
pod
and i explained this in the previous
chapters about when we started in
chapter 8 when we talked about
dependencies
flutter
can in can create ios applications ios
applications dependencies are
basically using uh cocoa pods
so cocoapods is a dependency management
system for ios applications
and
you need to just know that
you need to in order to be able to do
the trick that i just did you need to
install cocoapods and there is a good
website for that i mean you can i'll
bring up my and i say install cocoapods
and then i go here and you just say
cocoapods and then there is a command
that you need to issue in your computer
in order to install cocoapods okay
so um after you've installed cocoapods
then you can go into your ios project
and like
ask it to reinstall your dependencies so
the key here though was for me to
uncomment this platform line in the pod
file where my dependencies are managed
so i'm just going to say
now i'm supporting ios 13 at the minimum
all right and then i manually ask the io
the project to be recreated the ios
project to be recreated using pod
install repo update
so
after you've done that your dependencies
are generated and then i'm going to
right click on ios again
and i'm going to say oh i can say open
in xcode that's interesting will that
work i don't dare to be honest with you
do that
revealing finder and then i'm going to
do that and open a project so
i'm going to go now do command
do i do command b maybe not let's just
run it directly so
so
i'm gonna then bring up xcode and press
run again and let's see if it can then
find
those dependencies that it couldn't find
previously okay
so
we're gonna
let it do its thing
and it may take some time as you can see
because there's lots of dependencies we
dragged in
and all i think there were firebase off
we had firebase core we had cloud
firestore and also firebase analytics so
these dependencies
themselves can bring with them a lot of
other dependencies so
um it is important that
that then to know that
as i mentioned in the previous chapter
in chapter eight bringing dependencies
is not just
all
butterflies and balloons in the sky it
is actually a serious process you need
to consider what's bringing in a
dependency means to you and your team
and your application so
in this case we've only brought
dependencies that were officially done
by google and google is behind flutter
so i think
then the
you can basically trust anything that
has to do with firebase at least so
if it's released by the google team that
work on firebase of course
um so we're gonna let it do its thing
i'm gonna just tap here and i can see
that
it's building quite a lot of files
if everything goes according to
our plan
then
the result is going to be that
application run on this phone
so um
it would be very exciting actually to
see if this will
work as we intend to
and as i mentioned depending on the
computer that you're using this process
may take
in the beginning at least
quite a lot of time
so if you have a powerful computer it
may take less time and if you have a
little bit less powerful computer it may
take some more time
and
um now that we're waiting i should also
probably mention that this process of
waiting is only initially
something you need to do
once the build has been done once it
kind of like its artifacts will be
cached inside your computer
so that you don't have to rebuild the
entire project from the beginning okay
so
um
i'm gonna let it do its thing
and uh while we're waiting actually we
could talk a little bit about quicktime
which is a caption i brought here
if you're like me and you like to like
debug your applications on real phones
then you may want to see or show that
your your phone's screen
and
on your computer so for instance if
you're sharing your computer as a screen
with a co-worker and he or she wants to
also see your application running on
your phone you will need to use
something called a quicktime network
quicktime
so we're going to talk about that now
but before we do that let me just show
you
that here is now our flutter application
run on this telephone
so
there we go
our app is now running
now that we've done that all of this is
done you don't need xcode anymore so i'm
just going to press stop here and what
i'm going to do i'm actually going to
run our application from visual studio
code or flutter application on that
iphone all right so command shift b or
control shift b depending on which
platform you're using and say select
device
i'm going to choose my iphone 12 pro
then i'm going to go to run and say run
without debugging
you don't have any extensions oh not
this file open up your main darp file
okay
and then say run run without debugging
and you'll see it says launching
so this is going to actually consult
xcode and say that hey xcode here's the
flutter application run it on this
telephone
so
and to be honest with you i actually
didn't like this that it's using
automatic signing
it what may have happened is that when
we did flutter clea clean you may have
messed up our
profiles to be honest with you
and this is not a good sign it could be
that when i did flutter clean it
actually messed up the profile
so i'm going to open up xcode again and
bring up our application again and let's
have a look at our profiles
and i can see debug no it's fine it's
not automatic signing so
you don't have to worry about this
message that was printed to the screen
by uh by flutter so i don't think this
something that we need to worry about
so now that you've set that up then you
could actually run your application
directly from
visual studio code or android studio
depending on which environment you're
running your
flutter applications or debugging your
applications from
okay now let's say that that is done um
then what you need to do if you want to
mirror your application
screen on your computer then you can
bring up something called quicktime
player on your macintosh and then go to
file and then say movie recording now
this is probably going to hijack my
no it didn't hijack anything then i'm
going to go to
iphone 12 pro and see if it can mirror
that phone for me
uh
is it not able to do that is it because
i'm recording my screen or something i'm
gonna actually
[Music]
wait for this debug process to continue
let us do its thing first i think i'm
probably trying to do too many things at
the same time so
uh
[Applause]
i proxy i don't really know what i proxy
is
so
um
connecting to the vm service taking
longer than except expected and that
could be because my macintosh is
actually blocking something that flopper
needs so i'm going to go to privacy here
which is security and privacy and just
let iproxy to run
allow anyway
so that may help flutter then get its
process working
yeah that could be it because maybe my
macintosh just blocked that eye proxy so
i'm gonna stop this process and i'm just
going to say run run without debugging
again let's see if it can do its work
this time
launching and this time since it's
actually built the application
previously it shouldn't take long this
time before it can run the app
so it has already built the app once so
it shouldn't really take as long this
time
so
i can now see it says installing and
launching
so let's see if we can get that to work
xcode build done in eight seconds
and to be honest with you this is taking
longer than i expected it shouldn't take
this long to run the application and i
can see nothing was blocked this time
mac os cannot verify the developer of
iproxy and i'm just going to say open
i think there is something wrong with
the latest versions of mac os and how it
tries to for instance verify
various tools that
flutter is using internally but
everything went fine at the end i could
actually launch the application from
visual studio code and now it's running
inside my iphone
now i'm gonna stop this so now the app
as soon as i say stop the app is going
to stop working there what i'm going to
do then is to go to
quicktime
and see if we can get quicktime to
actually mirror
this iphone i'm going to unplug it
the phone and then plug it again
and see
if it understands that it has to mirror
the phone
i can see my quicktime is also giving me
some trouble
and it crashed
i mean this is live uh recording of this
session so you can see all the problems
a developer will have to fix and this is
me
so let's go to um and see if we can
get it to
let's see
if i can get it to
recognize this phone
and to be honest with you i mean i'm
actually doing this on a separate screen
so you don't have to see my face so much
but i can see that my macintosh for some
reason is not recognizing this telephone
so i cannot record it basically on this
um
uh on this screen right now
but if you're doing this at home it's
probably gonna work for you so uh
connect your phone with a cable to your
computer and then go to quicktime player
and then with quicktime player say new
movie recording and from movie recording
just from the drop down choose your
choose your um
phone and you'll be able to mirror your
screen so
um
now that that is done i mean we actually
got to a lot of hurdles that i hadn't
planned for we saw the iproxy thing
happening here
grateful that it happened
we saw the error with the pod
installation which is the dependency of
our project because there was no minimum
version set up for our flutter project
we fixed that we saw a problem with the
profile not being picked up
automatically because xcode had created
the certificate automatically we fixed
that
so
i mean i could
for instance now go and filter these out
from the video and kind of like when i
actually output the final course for you
then everything will just work perfectly
so
you don't have to see any of that
hiccup
but i don't want to do that to be honest
with you because i think it's so
important for you to see
what issues
you will get as you develop your
thoughts or applications it is important
i don't want to polish this um i don't
want to polish this uh course so much
that you think everything is perfect
from the absolute beginning and if
you're and if you're making mistakes
then something is wrong with the way
you're developing things but these
things happen you need to understand why
they happen then you need to learn how
to fix them so
with that said
uh
i think then we're good to go uh for ios
we've explained
everything we needed to explain
uh everything worked except for the
quicktime thing and i think that is
because
um i'm actually i have a lot of software
open here i am playing stop playing in
stuff recording stuff so it may be
because of that is a little bit confused
and who knows maybe my computer needs to
restart so
um
so with that said let's prepare
ourselves for the next chapter and that
is
to do the exact same thing with it for
ios hopefully with less explanation now
that we've gone through the basics for
android so
uh grab a cup of tea cup coffee whatever
you want and i'll see you in the next
chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 10 of this
flutter course
in this chapter we're going to look at
setting up our android
phone
or any android device that you may have
at hand in order for us to be able to
run our flutter code on it and now in
chapter nine we looked at how we can run
the application
and basically run our flash application
on an ios device and we set up the
provisioning profiles we set up the
certificates what else
the app id
at app store can on um
apple's developer website
i mean there is a lot of work to do and
you know that chapter took about an hour
to explain everything but
when it then comes to
the android side things are a lot easier
um
so
i thought in this chapter we're gonna
have a look at how we can
have an android phone for instance in my
case here i have a oneplus pro 7 pro
that is connected with a usb cable to my
computer so there's nothing special
about it it's just an android phone and
um
i prefer to actually as i mentioned in
the previous chapter in chapter 9 that
i prefer personally when i'm developing
applications to
developing floss applications to run my
applications on a real phone or a real
device as i'm testing now
um you may not know this if you're
coming from like a design background or
a background that's not really related
to mobile development in previously but
um
if you're developing applications for
only ios then you have something called
an ios simulator
um an io simulator is a program that
runs on your macintosh that comes with
xcode and the ios sdk that allows you to
simulate how ios internally works and it
allows you to install your applications
from xcode directly or from from flutter
directly into the simulator and simulate
basically how your application will be
perceived by your actual users
if you're developing applications for
android then there is something called
an android emulator now an emulator is
quite different from a simulator in that
an emulator as its name indicates it
actually tries to emulate everything
about the operating system and the
device so for instance an android
emulator for an old device for instance
that you may get a hold of a device
that's five six years old
it will actually work slower
than an android emulator for a very
modern device
but had you done the same thing for an
ios simulator and simulated an ios
device that's five years old
it would still perform
at today's like at your computer's uh
speed because it is simulating ios it's
not actually emulating it the way it
really works on a phone so
when it comes to android you have this
possibility to run your application on
an emulator which is a lot closer to the
actual device that your user will be
using
so it is not the exact perfect copy in
most cases so it's not gonna be like
working exactly as a real physical phone
but it's a lot closer to the actual
physical device that an ios simulator is
so
given that background i still prefer to
run my flutter applications on a real
phone
and in this chapter
if you're interested in that if you're
if you have an android phone and you
want to for instance deploy your flutter
application on an android phone and test
it while you're programming it then this
chapter is for you
now i also have to say that um
mean
[Music]
you don't
you don't have to do this but for the
entire entirety of this course i'm
actually going to be
as we're developing the application the
notes application i'm personally going
to
be using my android phone
so that um
so as we basically do hot reloads and
then we write some code and we want to
test it i'm not going to show any
emulator i'm not going to show any
simulator i'm actually going to show my
real android phone working
now i'm not going to show it with just
like
i'm not going to install the application
here and just show you like this because
this is not going to work it's not a
good way of showing things to uh to
someone watching this course so what
we're gonna do is
as the first
task in this uh chapter we are going to
install an application on our um
computer called scrcpy
okay
now scrcp cpy is a
is an open source project
um
that is on github with
many thousand stars and it is
not like a dependency it's not something
that you're going to build into your
flutter application but it's actually
utility you're going to install on your
computer okay so
your computer will will then be able to
mirror your android
phone or your android tablet on your
computer's screen so
and this scr cpy is absolutely beautiful
it's one of my absolute favorite
utilities to have when doing mobile
development
and the reason behind that is that
unlike the
um
solution that i showed in the previous
chapter which is quicktime quicktime
player where you mirror your ios
telephone on your computer but you
cannot interact with that mirrored image
you still have to bring up your
telephone and interact with the
telephone and see the interactions
either on the phone itself or on your
screen unlike that scrcpy allows you to
actually interact with your phone or
your tablet or your android phone or
tablet
from your computer screen so you can
actually take your mouse and then go to
that screen and tap on a button and it
will actually tap on that button on your
android telephone so
it is magical it's beautiful it's open
source and free so if you have an
android tablet or an android phone and
you're following along with this course
i highly recommend that we install
scrcpy together actually as we're going
to do
in this course
so
i'm just going to take in my notes here
that i've explained that so
um before actually we go about
installing scrcpy we need to
do um we need to install adb
and
this adb is like um
i believe it actually stands for android
debugger or something let's see what
actually adb stands for
i'm gonna bring up a um
a safari window here as you can see adb
stands for android debug bridge and adb
is a great tool if you want to for
instance be able to talk with your
android telephone all from the command
line so you can send it a message and
say hey take a screenshot
hey do this or click here or yet
close this application whatever so you
basically send commands to your android
telephone or tablet through your
terminal it's um it's fantastic
and
with
adb i mean having adb install your
computer then you can actually install
scrcpy
which uses adb in order to talk to your
telephone and send commands to it and
receive images from it etc so
with that said we need to install adb so
i'm going to close this turn window here
and i'm going to bring up terminal
i'm going to increase the size of this
terminal window so you see what i'm
doing okay
so in here then i'm going to say
brew install
cask android platform tools okay
so this will then allow you to
install if i can
using android platform tools then um you
will be able to grab adb from that so
android platform tools insta
installation actually includes adb all
right
so
um i can see that i mean for me you can
see that i've already installed android
platform tools so i get this message
here saying that well you've already
installed it
but if you have not installed android
platform tools before you will running
this command will actually install it
for you now i don't want to reinstall it
so i'm just not going to do this
suggested command here but just know
that before you install scr cpy you will
need to get adb up and running okay
and that comes in android platform tools
all right
so
let's let me just go into my notes and
say that we've talked about adb so after
you've done adb we need to go and i'm
going to bring up safari again
let's see if i can bring up the window
here so you can see what i'm doing as
well then i'm going to say scr cpy
okay and then you will see that the
first suggested website is on github and
this is exactly where you need to go
so go to scrcpy here and you will see
information about how you can actually
install scrcpy and it says on linux you
can do apt installer crcpy on windows
you can do a download here
and on mac os then you can do brew
install
scr cpy
so
i've already done that so i've already
actually installed scrcpy so i don't
have to do anything special
and um you can see it actually tells you
here i'm going to increase the size of
this window so you can see a little bit
better
and it will tell you here that you need
adb accessible from your path if you
don't have it yet then do that command
that i mentioned to you okay
so
after you've done the installation on
your computer then you should be able to
bring up a terminal so i'm going to
bring up terminal here
and
as you can see here i have my android
telephone and it the screen looks like
this right now so it's just on the home
screen nothing special
then
i want to bring up scrcpy
but before you do that
if this is the first time you're doing
this process you will probably need to
enable something called usb debugging on
your android telephone
and
depending on how your
what your android phone looks like or
what it is
the usb debugging when you plug your
android telephone it will kind of show
you
um
a screen like this
so i'm going to enlarge this a little
bit so you can see better
so this dialog will pop up on your
android telephone saying that oh do you
want to allow this computer to do
debugging on this um on this telephone
and what you need to do is just to say
always allow from this computer and then
press the ok button this is only so that
you will be first of all able to install
and debug your
flutter applications
all from visual studio code or from
android studio right on your android
telephone or tablet
and also it will allow you to run scrcpy
which in turn uses adb
in order in order to communicate with
your device okay
so
that is for
usb debugging all right
so what we need to do is actually bring
up scr cpy so
in terminal i'm just going to say ser
cpy
and as you can see here it's going to
talk to my android telephone and it
brought up a window which i'm going to
slowly bring here to this screen so you
can see
so
i'm going to leave the terminal here
because the terminal is actually fueling
this thing so if i close my terminal
this is also going to be closed so just
keep this terminal open or if you're
using item for instance like i'm using
then you can bring up a new tab and
continue working with another
command line otherwise you can just
close it or you can just minimize this
if you're if you're bothered by it so
as you can see now i have my android
phone here
mirrored on my screen i'm actually going
to do this so you can see it a little
bit better i'm going to bring it right
here in between so this is my actual
android phone so if i click here with my
mouse it actually interacts with my
phone so
i can bring up my phone here
so you kind of see them side by side
and if on the
if on the scrcpy screen here i press the
back button
you will see that my android screen
changes
one more time click on google
so it's really interacting with my
android telephone here okay
so
i highly suggest that you actually
install sdrcpy to be honest with you
it's a great great tool if you're into
mobile development or if you want to
become a mobile developer so
um
and regarding what i said earlier about
devices i think in
you will get really really far with the
ios simulator and the android emulator
however
i personally should suggest that you
spend
and invest some money into getting
devices for for yourself they don't have
to be top of the line
latest devices but
one android telephone and one ios
telephone
or even tablets will do but preferably
telephones you don't even have to have
sim cards in them just just the
telephone device physically itself so
um
and
i mean if you're getting into mobile
development you will kind of after many
years kind of have a lot of telephones
anyways because you will get like this
year's new telephone and then two years
later you get another telephone so you
kind of pile them up
um
and you could use those all telephones
then as test telephones as we call them
all right
so
that's that part now what we need to do
next is to now that our android phone is
connected here
what we need to do is to go to visual
studio code into our project
and choose that um
so choose our let me see bring up visual
studio code here if i can visual studio
code
this is i have so many screens here so
it's a little bit of a challenge to
actually
line them up all here so what i'll do
here is i will get rid of the side
window all right and i will bring up
then scr cpy on the right hand side and
then just resize the screen a little bit
here
and then like this so i have you this is
like my usual setup so i have visual
studio code here on the left and then i
have my android phone mirrored on the
right hand side okay
so what then you'll need to do after
you've done all of this work is in
visual studio code just say command
shift p on mac or ctrl shift b on linux
and
windows and if you're using android
studio i don't to honestly know the
commands there to select a device in
flutter they may be like a drop down or
something so please do that
so here i'm just going to say command
shift b and i'm going to say flutter
select device okay
and in select device i'm actually going
to choose my
android telephone which is the one being
mirrored here
choose an android phone and then i'm
going to say run run without debugging
okay
so
let's then see
that you can see here it says launching
dart on gm 19 blah blah in debug mode so
since it's an android application now
all of a sudden we just switch from ios
to android previously our application
was being like our source code was being
compiled by xcode
and now since we're trying to deploy to
an android telephone it's the gradle
it's gradle basically that's taking care
of the build process so if you're an
android developer then you know that
basically gradle zero build system and
yeah
it is working um
it is basically doing the build in the
background
so i'm actually so glad that we got this
error right now so i'm gonna take here
in my notes that we've talked about in
vs code select android and then show
android phone mirroring working okay
so
you see here we got some errors
actually when we talked about in chapter
what chapter are we on we're on chapter
10. in chapter 9 when we talked about
running our application on ios we
actually got something similar
there was an error saying that oh your
uh
dependencies firebase they need this
version but you're on that version and
and the under
and the code that actually solved it if
you remember we went to our pod file i
just put this platform here saying ios
13 because you see we have four
dependencies at the moment we have
firebase auth we have firebase core
analytics and something else which i
don't remember let me have a look at the
notes here
there were core auth cloud firestore and
firebase analytics
these four dependencies they have their
own requirements so they say that we as
dependencies cannot be installed on an
application that for instance supports a
very old android os or a very old ios
version so these dependencies are
putting requirements on your project so
and we fixed that yes uh in the in
chapter nine we fixed that um by going
into the pod file and
commenting out this basically removing
the comment from this line and changing
it from 9
to 13. so we fix it like that for ios
but how do we do it for android now we
get a lot of great information here and
it says that you kind of need to find
this debug default config and min sdk
version okay so let's look for default
config so i'm going to copy that text
and i'm going to then command shift f in
visual studio code and search for it and
as you can see here we have a little um
flutter version name and then flutter
version code to integer
and i can see here there is
information about flutter versions like
if you go to our build gradle
and
there is a flutter version code to
integer that is the
and the where's the main sdk here min
sdk version okay so i'm going to search
for min sdk version
and here i can see it is 19 here it is
19. and android min sdk version
19 so there's actually quite a lot of
places where
19 is mentioned all right
and the error itself let's read it
requires a higher android sdk version
fix this by adding the following to the
file build gradle android default config
min sdk version okay so
if we look at the default config here
it's talking about this thing min sdk
version i can see that previously this
used to be a number and recently it has
been changed to flutter min sdk version
so i'm going to bring up a safari window
and i'm going to say change flutter min
sdk version so let's see what people are
actually suggesting is there a good
command that allows us to do this
you see people are still saying that we
need to do it like that by changing it
to a specific version but i believe
there should be a better way of doing
this instead of hard-coding it um
with the new flutter project with the
flutter style you're unable to change
the mini sdk version and local
properties
great okay so if we go to a file called
local.properties that's what they're
saying here so
i'm gonna
try to find local properties and i can
see here
there is an sdk set here
but there is no min sdk version
so
we probably need to just go and fix that
up so i'm going to copy paste and i'm
just going to say flutter.sdk version
19. okay save that file then i'm going
to go back to the main dart and then say
run without debugging let's see what
happens this time
and if it accepts that
local properties change that we just
made
and it's still saying that it won't be
able to users running so
uh what we could do in here to be honest
with you is just troubleshooting so
let's just say go back to the root
folder of your application and say
flutter clean android
why is it doing the xcode workspace
and then say flutter
pop get
so if this works properly then it should
have cleaned the android code for us and
like put the version 19 in our build
gradle like this should actually resolve
to 19 so let's go to main dart and just
give it one more try if this if this
solution doesn't work then we
unfortunately have to go into our
build gradle file and and do what was
recommended and put the min sdk version
there as a constant value of 19 just to
get the code
compiling so
let's have a look here at um
what our gradle build is gonna do
so
i don't really know what happened with
it
i it doesn't seem to really be doing
anything so one more try run without
debugging and see what happens launching
i'm gonna have a look at my android
phone here as well running gradle task
assemble debug
and for me it's not running anything at
the moment on this on this phone so what
we're gonna do is let's go to
i mean this solution didn't work so
i'm gonna remove that and i'm gonna go
to build gradle and put the
target sdk version i think that was the
min sdk version sorry
and here we're just gonna say 19 instead
okay
like that like it was actually suggested
to us so
um let's then go to main dart and then
say run without debugging one more time
and if this solution doesn't work i may
actually have to like restart the visual
studio code if it's kind of confused for
some reason
because usually when you say
gradle like when you start the build
process it actually gives you some
feedback it either says that something
failed or that yeah i um
it then ran successfully and in this
case i can see it's not running so i'm
just gonna say quit visual studio code
okay
and then i'm gonna bring up visual
studio code so i have a lot of projects
usually so
i'm gonna
[Music]
minimize all of these things and i'm
going to only open
our my notes application
so let's go in there
to our my notes application and let's
give this a try one more time i'm going
to go to run without debugging and let's
see what happens
oh now it's choosing iphone 13 pro in
debug mode so that's because i restarted
visual studio code and it doesn't know
which device to run on so i'm going to
say select device and then choose my
android phone again
run run without debugging
and hopefully crossing my fingers here
that
since we've changed the
um
version number then it's going to work
and i can see here
i see so now it's com complaining about
multi-decks so i mean this is great
stuff i'm so glad that we're seeing all
these errors because usually we don't
have the possible i mean usually you see
in tutorials that yeah everything's
working fine uh he clicked there and
clicked there and everything worked but
here we're actually getting to the point
where you see every issue that could
arise and then we're gonna fix it
together and this is like a day in the
life of a software developer things go
wrong but then you'll have to fix it so
um this multi-dex is something that
you'll have to
configure and we're going to say
use multi-dex flag so
i'm going to go to safari and i'm going
to paste it here
um and then there is a solution
hopefully somewhere in our default
config you see it says multi-dex enabled
so
let's go to your to the
build gradle in app which is right here
you see android app build gradle in your
default config as it says here
multi-decks enabled just bring it here
it's it there
and then go to your dependencies at the
bottom of this file right here and bring
implementation multi-decks right there
okay so i'm just going to paste it right
there go back to my main guard file here
and then say run run without debugging
so
let's see what happens
and there are some warnings here that
are printed in red you don't have to
worry about them so much right now
there are warnings as their name
suggests so um you don't have to worry
so much to be honest with you as i
mentioned
so there we go here is um our flutter
application now working and running on
um
on the actual phone so
i'm gonna bring then the phone here
and you can see it is showing the exact
same thing so if i with my mouse go over
you can't see that because you're
actually seeing my face
so
um and then you will see the value 3
printed
here as well so that's that's great
stuff
um
then
i don't know why this
uh screen is rotated
i rotate it back
oh it's because my phone is actually
rotated so i'm gonna rotate it back so
it's uh
it's not rotated in the wrong
orientation great so we got a lot of
problems to be honest with you there um
but that's okay that's usually what
happens when we're working with mobile
development at least in the beginning
when you're doing the setup so i'm
actually
grateful that we're getting these errors
so you see them so you don't just think
everything is going to work from the
absolute beginning so
even though as i said in the
introduction i haven't planned all of
this that these errors come up i don't
want things to be perfect so even though
that is happening but i'm still quite
grateful that they are happening so
what we need to talk about now is
something called screen sleeping and um
as you're developing your uh application
on your android telephone or tablet
you'll notice that you will run your
application on the phone or the tablet
and then after
after a short while your screen will go
to sleep which means the screen will be
locked
and then when you try to then rerun or
rerun your application or re refresh
your application then you will get an
error from flutter saying that it cannot
deploy the application because the
device is locked so
that is quite annoying that the
telephone does it but it is for a good
reason the telephones like for security
purposes they have to lock the screen so
that if you leave it somewhere on a
bench or something in a park and you
just forget it and you go away then it
is locked so no one's going to get
access to your telephones
data with that said what we need to do
is disable it while you're developing
your applications because
what you want is a telephone that's
always there is available the screen
doesn't lock so you can always deploy a
newer version of our application to it
or as or as long as you
you don't lock it yourself manually
so what we're going to do is i'm going
to bring up the phone here so you see
what i'm doing i'm going to go here
i'm going to go to the settings
screen um here
and
you will probably need to i mean in
order for you to actually even be able
to run your application and do funky
things with your application on your
telephone you need to enable something
called developer remote so developer
mode on android and on ios is a series
of development tools that the phone
provides only to developers and in order
to get those tools you need to perform a
series of actions like a monkey or
something on your telephone and
um i'm not going to provide instructions
exactly how to do that for all different
phones because depending on the
manufacturer of your telephone
especially if it's on android then
developer mode is brought
into life in a different way so what you
need to do is to find out the
manufacturer of your telephone and the
model of your telephone here is a
oneplus pro 7 i believe and then google
and say oneplus pro 7 developer options
or developer mode
then you'll get some information about
how to enable that i've already done
that so if i go to i believe it's
utilities or sorry i think it's system
then
you can see there then i have an option
called developer options okay
so in order to disable screen sleeping
you have to go to developer option and
say stay awake
and that is by default disabled all
right
so
um
we've now then talked about um
developer tools and we've talked about
that you can interact with your
telephone uh using scrcpy so
to be honest with you i think i think
that's all you need to know for
um for the android setup there is not
much more to talk about the rest is just
developing our application as usual and
then running it on the android phone and
then mirroring the screen using a crcpy
so that's what i'm going to do for the
entirety of this course i'm going to
primarily run the application run our
application that we're going to develop
in this course on this telephone and
mirror the screen using scr cpy
but you may choose to use an ios
simulator or an android emulator or an
ios phone or a tablet whatever
so i can't provide
descriptions about how to do all of
those things because that is a complete
course of its own but at least now you
have the tools and the necessary
information in order to understand how
you can actually deploy to an iphone and
an android phone all right
so
uh
with that said now we can say that we're
actually good to go on android
um and in the next chapter which is
chapter 11 we're going to get to some
juicy stuff which is uh setting up our
project on firebase and if you remember
from the introduction we're going to use
firebase for our back end
so um
then
you know what's coming in the next
chapter and uh now you have the tools
necessary in order to get the app
running so with that said then let's go
and
configure our firebase project in
chapter 11.
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 11
of this course
in this chapter we're going to talk
about our back end setup which is with
firebase
um and i'm as i as i've said it before i
kind of assume that you've gone through
the chapters of this
course chronologically so you started
from the absolute beginning introduction
and then
you're following along so there's lots
and lots of lots of information as you
can see it's about eight hours of
information before this chapter
so i feel like since i've explained
everything so thoroughly in all those
chapters i'm not going to go through all
that again
so i will jump over stuff that i've
already explained so i if you haven't
watched those chapters i
really suggest that you at least skim
over them a little bit so you see
so you get the gist of it
um now i'm looking at my notes and i can
see
that in this chapter as the caption
shows here we're gonna set up our back
end our backend is using firebase and
while developing this course i
contemplated creating
a like as a part of this course have a
custom backend as well that we do with
django i personally do django
development uh for back-end and websites
like rest apis and also for
simple websites as well
but to be honest with you if i then go
and create a simple back-end with django
and then show you how to integrate with
that using flutter
it really has nothing to do with flutter
like the backend part has nothing to do
with flutter itself so
having that
issue in the beginning of this course i
was faced with a challenge of do i go
into the rabbit hole of creating custom
back
for this course
and walk you through also creating a
custom package which has nothing to do
with flutter and flutter is the reason
you were watching this course so i
was faced with that challenge of whether
i should do that or just use uh firebase
and i choose and i chose firebase simply
because it is a product by google it is
kind of like serverless so it is a
server without you actually having to
write code as such
so i picked firebase for its simplicity
so that we can get the backend working
up and running without so much work and
i hope that you understand that that is
the reason that we're not doing a custom
back-end but firebase is a very reliable
uh
back-end created by google and it has
all google's financial backing for
further
developments and for support so you
don't have to worry if you're picking
firebase and if you're thinking oh is it
going to continue being supported
the quick answer is yes it is going to
be supported it is so big everyone's
using it and it's too big even to fail i
would say right now at least for
the
uh upcoming uh next few years i would
say
i can't predict the
future for 10 20 years in the future but
for now you don't have to worry about
that so
um
so that's what we are going to do in
this chapter i'm just going to take it
in my notes um
now previously when uh flutter came out
like in year 2020 or even the beginning
of 2021
if you want to integrate with
firebase you have to do a lot of custom
work
now
in the recent versions of flutter
there is a
a command that you can issue from your
terminal it is called flutter fire cli
and this command
is amazing because like the work that
you have to previously do manually a lot
of custom work dragging files and p
lists and jsons configurations app ids
etc etc it was such a big
undertaking that a lot of developers
would make a lot of mistakes during that
process and it was just not good so
um
there is now a command that you can
issue from from your terminal which
allows you to do all that custom work
but it does it for you so you don't have
to do do that manually so
as i provided here there is a link i'm
going to open that link
if i can somewhere let's see if i can
bring up safari
it opens in a
wrong screen i'll bring that screen here
so you'll see it as well
enlarge that screen and also enlarge the
font so it is more visible
so you can see it says fluffifier
overview
and it says get to know firebase for
flutter
we recommend starting with the get to
know firebase for flutter code lab and
video okay so there's a video here if
you want to watch it
and uh and it says okay if you're
migrating your existing project then
look at the migration guide migrating if
you're not familiar with that term uh if
you're not coming from a software
engineer background migrating economy so
you have an existing thing and you want
to
make it newer like
and put in new stuff in it so you kind
of migrate your information from the old
project to the new one so
but in this case we don't have to worry
about that because we're we've created a
brand new project so there's no existing
firebase installation in our application
that we have to worry about okay
there's a lot of information here you
can see it says using the cli etc etc
and that is actually what we're going to
do now
we are going to have a look at how we
can install the flutter fire cli
and you can see here it says you should
execute the dart pop global activate
flussifier cli
and then you issue flutter fire
flussifier config so let's start by
copying this code from here copy it and
i'm going to bring up my terminal
and i'm going to increase the size of my
terminal so you actually see what is
happening here okay so i'm gonna paste
that command in and i'm gonna let it do
its thing
i've already done this installation
before so for me it may actually go a
little bit smoother or a little bit
faster but for you it may take a little
bit longer depending on whether you've
already installed flat of rsli before or
not
so now that that is installed the next
thing you will have to do is you will
actually need to make sure i mean it's
not provided in the documentation but
it's something that i'm providing for
you because i know that i've personally
run into this issue before
so
um
this flutter fire cli it will give you
this command as you can see here flutter
fire okay and if i in my terminal say
which flutter fire
you can see that flutter fire is
installed in this folder so it's under
my personal folder on my computer
slash dot pop cache slash bin and then
right there so unfortunately when you
install lots of fire cli it doesn't
it doesn't tell your terminal where it
is installed so if you then immediately
after that say flutter fire and then
blah blah blah as it is mentioned here
classifier configure your terminal will
most probably say that what is flutter
fire
so
it's not provided here in the
documentation but i'm telling you here
as you can see in the caption that you
need to tell your terminal where flutter
fire is actually installed okay
so
um
then what you'll need to do is uh to do
as i've mentioned here you can see i've
said that you need to change your path
and include your home folder slash pop
cache slash bin so if i go to my
terminal configuration if i say um
in
vshrc
you can see at the top here somewhere i
should have there you see it says export
path and i say okay my new path is the
old path plus using this uh double
column here or column
this folder as i've mentioned here in
the captions at the bottom of the screen
so you will need to do this as well so
i'm going to quit vim now and then after
you've done that make sure that you
source that
configuration so in my case i would have
to say source
zsh rc and that will read the paths
um
fresh otherwise you could also take the
high road and like
close your terminal completely
terminated and then start it again which
in turn reads the configuration and
brings flutter fire a path
into
existence
if you don't want to source that's what
i mean
so
now we've talked about that now let's
actually talk about what the firebase
cli is
it is a um actually let me
make sure i tick all of these items that
i
talked about
in
right now let me just mark them as done
in my notes
so
um
so what you need to do now is what we
need to do now is to talk about firebase
cli
and um
as you can see here is a cli to help us
interact with firebase right from our
terminal now
um
this this used to be done manually
previously in that you would have to go
to firebase and like create a whole
separate project and then integrate that
project into your flosser application so
you don't have to do any of that anymore
so
um what you need to do now is as the
next step is to install the firebase cli
which does all of that work for you
so i've provided here as you can see
there is a command here that you can
issue
and then you can go to a firebase google
com docs cli install cli mac blah blah
so i'm actually going to go to that
location
in my web browser here so you can see
what i'm doing
here
and you will see there's a lot of
information provided here i'm going to
bring up the uh i'm going to make the
size a little bit bigger i'm going to
bring my face maybe to the bottom right
as well so you can see more information
on the screen
and you can see for mac or linux then
there is
yeah let's go here mag you can install
the firebase cli for macro linux using
one of the following options
so standalone binary blah blah so you
need to have a look at this
documentation on on how you can install
the firebase cli on your on your
computer whether you're using mac or
whether you're using linux or windows so
so
after you've done that after you've
installed the firebase
cli you will actually need to
log in
in your into your account using that
firebase
cli
so
let's let's do that let me actually in
here um let's bring up our project uh in
visual studio code so i'm gonna bring it
up here
and bring up the right caption as well
so you see what we're talking about
we're going to talk about firebase login
and log out you see when you
want to integrate your flutter
application with firebase you need to
create a
firebase project on something called the
firebase console
so this project is pretty much the
configuration of your firebase backend
on firebase's console on their website
so you need to configure a backend so
what we need to do here is now before we
can actually configure it back in
in your terminal you need to tell
firebase what user you have because i
personally have many google accounts and
any one of those google accounts can
potentially have many flutter sorry many
firebase projects
because firebase projects are linked to
your google accounts okay
now in order for our firebase cli to
understand where it needs to create the
project you need to tell it to log in
with an account all right so
the way to do that is to bring up
terminal and as you can see here is my
terminal
and i'm going to clean this a little bit
i'm going to bring up the font as well
so it's quite ginormous and that's okay
so what you need to do now is to tell it
to log in
so i'm going to say firebase
login okay
it's gonna do its work and it's telling
me i'm already logged in with this
account if you haven't logged in with an
account then you're gonna get a prompt
telling you uh okay which email and
password do you wanna log in with so
now
um it may be actually worth it to be
honest with you for me to log out right
now so that you see the entire process
so
i'm a bit hesitant to log out because
uh i actually have protected my google
account with a security key
so
i don't have the key right here and i
hope that i can find it so
for the sake of for the sake of actually
going through this process together with
you so you see how it works i'm gonna
log out
so let's log out here
so i'm saying firebase logout
and it says there is a new version of a
firebase tool so let's copy this here
and i'm gonna see if we can install
um what did it say
npm install
global so let's copy that here global
firebase tools okay
if it can do its work then before we can
continue
and npm is something called a node
package manager and it is kind of like
if you're working with node.js if you're
developing for instance node
applications
which you which you don't have to know
about it's just a way it's like a
tool kit for creating applications uh
remove the existing file and try again
or npm with force okay
npm install global
with dash dash force i think
yeah
so it's it's like a dependency
management for
node applications and firebase tools is
a node application so that's all you
need to know really i mean there's there
are courses available about node and
node.js then you can actually have a
look at how they work etc so i'm not
going to go into details about that so
before i could i mean i could have
actually done a firebase logout without
all of this but i just want to show you
that things aren't planned like i can't
perfectly plan things here and when i
tried to log out it said oh there's a
new version of node available blah blah
so
now that i think sorry there's a new
version of firebase tools available that
you can use that you can install with
npm so
i did that so let's now say uh firebase
logout
okay so the logit actually was
successful
previously and
so let's now say firebase login
and it says allow firebase to collect
cli usage and error reporting
information i'm gonna say as a developer
to be honest with you
you may you may be tended to say no like
here but if you are a developer you can
put your shoe you can put yourself in
the shoes of another developer working
at google working for firebase and they
are trying to get some information about
how you use the cli and whether they can
learn from your usage of the cli in
order to make the cli better so i
usually say yes to these things
especially if there's a developer asking
for permission so but you can say no to
this if you want to so i'm just going to
say yes
and you can see here then there's a
screen provided here asking me to log in
with one of my google accounts all right
and
i'm going to pick my company's google
account because that's what i usually
use all right so i'm going to choose
that and it says firebase cli wants to
access your google account and it says
okay what permissions it's going to use
you can have a look at this information
if you want to
if it concerns you so if you if you're
concerned about any of these things
please go and read the
links provided here
i'm just going to say allow
and once that is done you will see that
it says firebase cli login successful
and then you can pretty much just close
this window safely
and now it says logged in as pixelityav
gmail.com so i can say firebase login
again and that would be the prompt that
you saw in the beginning of this video
that you are logged in alright
good
that was a lot of information now now
that you are logged in with the firebase
cli you actually need to configure a
firebase project all right and we do
that with the flutter fire cli which we
installed in the beginning of this
chapter using this command dart pop
global activate all right
so what you need to do now is to
issue
the flutter fire configure
command as i've shown here down at on
the left hand side so i'm going to do
that flutter fire configure
so it will fetch all the projects that
i've already created in my
google account and it says okay these
are the projects available flash chat
fluffer note guessing chords random
project testing or you can create a new
project
now i'm going to choose create a new
project here okay
and
it says okay enter a project id for your
new firebase project so what i'm going
to do here is i'm just going to type my
notes all right
so
as you can see my notes
is the name of our flutter project as
well so my notes now i'm going to say
okay i'm going to create the same
project called my notes okay i'm going
to press enter here
i says yeah i'm going to create it
and it's probably
i mean you can see that we immediately
got an error saying that
this project already exists and you can
see
um
command blah blah blah yeah fail to
create a project because there's already
a project with
with id mynotes please try again with a
unique project id so
this is basically telling us that hey
someone else has created my notes and it
wasn't one of the projects that we had
created because if you if you have a
look at your
if you open uh your web browser and say
firebase console
go to your firebase console
and uh let me make sure that i'm logged
in with my pixelity account yes
and
if i have a look let's see dismiss let's
see
get started firebase helps you watch
demo
yeah we are logged in with that account
so i can actually see maybe i don't have
any projects set up here which is a
little bit weird because
we actually saw that there were some
projects set up under this account so i
don't understand why the firebase
console so it's not showing them
um
firebase console backed by google
firebase console google
yeah there they are okay so it is on
console.firebase.google okay
and i can see that my notes application
is not an application that i own i
haven't created that so
what it is saying is that globally
firebase projects have an identifier and
now i've entered an identifier that is
already taken so
what i'm going to do then is i'm going
to issue the same command uh
firebase flutter fire configure and this
time i'm going to give it a little bit
more information about the project name
so that makes it a little bit more
unique so i'm going to choose
create a new project
and then in here in the name of the
project i'm going to say mynotes
flutter project
maybe someone has already taken this as
well
i don't know
so it's doing its thing it's doing its
magic basically so let's have a look
and i mean
this is okay that is taking some time it
is doing a lot of work it's setting up
like the ios project and android project
etc so
this thing used to take a lot of time to
do by hand like maybe 10 folds the
amount of time that this
cli is taking so i'm not so bothered by
the fact that it's taking some time so
and here it will actually tell you okay
which platforms do you want to select
and as i said like flutter allows you to
create web applications android
applications ios applications and also
uh
desktop applications or four platforms
and then here it says okay which ones do
you want to create
for our project right now you can just
say android and ios you don't have to
worry about like
um
mac os or linux or windows and web but
you have the ability to do that if you
want to so choose android and ios for
now and press enter
so it's gonna do its work
so let it do its magic
and now this is this is the amazing part
that you had to do manually before you
had to previously go
and register like your application with
apple and then go and register bundle
identifier and then put the bundle
identifier manually in firebase and then
download some files put those files in
your ios and android project now
now you don't have to do that anymore
here it just tells you which bundle
identifier are you using for your
project and if you remember from before
when we created our flutter project from
the beginning we said flutter create and
then an organization which for me was s
e dot pixolity do you remember that
command
it kind of looked like um
i mean if i bring up terminal maybe i
can even go back to it flutter create do
you remember this command i will zoom
into it a little bit so you can see
better this is how we actually created
our project we said flutter create.org
as he pixeled in my notes so the bundle
identifier for this application will be
sepixolity.mynotes
however since sc pixelity is the reverse
domain for me this won't this won't be
the case for you so
go back to how you created that
identifier for a project using your
organization name and you now you have
to paste that in here so you will see
i'm going to say s e
pixelity
dot my notes okay
so enter that
and it's going to configure your ios
project for you
and that was it so
it has now
set up everything necessary for your
project to work so i mean you may you
may just think oh well this was this was
so little and what did it actually do
but for me who's been working with
firebase and flutter for a very long
time
this is all magical because it did a lot
of work it configured your application
on the firebase console it actually
registered an android and an ios project
hooked into this firebase project
downloaded the configuration files place
them in the exact correct place in your
application
so it did a lot of work but you don't
really have to know about that so
um now if you want to kind of see the
result of it if you see here the output
of this says that there is an identifier
associated with your ios app and then
there's an identifier associated with
your android app
so that's what we're going to do now
let's now make sure that these
identifiers are correct and that the
bundle identifier that we provided to
the cli is also placed in the
configuration file correctly so
copy this for instance ios identifier
that was created for you so copy it
and then search for it in your entire
project and then you'll find a little
file here and let me bring it down
it is called
firebaseoptions.dart
so this is where ios is configured and
let me bring this like that so you don't
see it
and this is where the android project is
configured you can see the um
app id is right here and the api key is
right there so don't worry about this i
mean you should not show your api key
and app id to anybody um so but since
i'm developing this course for you i
have to show it i can't just go and
censor it but don't worry about it by
the time you're seeing this um video by
the time you're seeing this course i've
already deleted this project from
firebase so there's not going to be any
security risk involved so
um
so that project isn't going to exist
even if you know the api key on app id
so don't worry about that but if you are
developing your own application just
kind of be careful who you share your
api key and app id with all right
that was a lot of information a lot a
lot a lot so um
and i'm gonna actually tick here
that we've talked about that
i create a new project
and yeah that's that's all working as it
should
so i'm also gonna go here in the
captions and i can see that i have some
information here about enabling
multi-decks and multi-dex was something
that we've already enabled in the
previous chapter which was chapter 10
for the android project so
now everything should be working as it
did before to be honest with you so if
you in your visual studio code or
android studio if you're developing
under your flutter app with android
studio you can also
go and select your device to run on now
in the previous chapter you saw that for
the entirety of this chat in this course
i'm gonna use an android phone to
develop uh our application so you may
choose to use an io simulator an android
emulator or an android phone or tablet
or ios phone or tablet so but i'm gonna
use a real android phone and as you saw
we have the ability to bring up scr cpy
to mirror the android screen so i'm
going to bring it right here
change the size of visual studio codes
window a little bit so you can see the
android um telephone right there as well
then what i'm going to do
just to make sure that the project runs
after all of this work that we've done
so that we haven't broken anything
really let's then go and
debug the application
sorry run it without debugging and this
is this is why you will see this is the
result of all the work that we've done
pretty much nothing
this is like
i mean
it sounds funny to say it because we did
a lot of work with the firebase project
but there is nothing that you can see on
the screen and that's that's the reality
of doing software development you may be
putting a lot of work sometimes in doing
something and this result isn't
immediately visible all right
so but what you have done in this
chapter was that you actually set up
your back end with just a few commands
you installed two clis the flutter fire
cli and the firebase cli you logged in
with firebase cli and then you set up
your backend with the flutter fire cli
all right
now just to make sure everything is set
up properly also you can bring up your
web browser i'm gonna bring it up here
and i'm gonna say console.firebase
and
let me make sure
that we have
our notes app here you can see my node
slatter project
and you can click on it and you can see
how it is set up for you you can see
there is an android app setup and an ios
app setup so
you didn't have to really do anything
now there's lots of things you can do
with firebase which we're going to
actually play with throughout this
course but not right now just make sure
that your
firebase project is created for you by
logging into console.firebase.google.com
many dots
all right and we've talked about this
now running the application on an
android telephone so
that was already set up so we don't have
to talk about that now
now that you've seen that you've set up
your backend you're ready to go and uh
so i can say congratulations so that's
in order
now
the android setup is already done so i
can see that that is set up we don't
have to talk about that either
however
what we do need to talk about is what
we're gonna
discuss in the next chapter
so
in the next chapter we are for the first
time in this course we are going to talk
about
the uh footer code actual thoughts or
code we're going to start writing a
simple registration screen so using this
registration screen our
right now hypothetical users are going
to
look at the screen and say okay i don't
have an account with this application
i'm going to register myself so
then you will
be able to they will be able to enter
their email address a password of their
uh choosing press some sort of a button
and we will then talk with firebase and
say here's a new user register that
person okay so that's all for the next
chapter which is chapter 12. so grab a
cup of coffee cup of tea whatever you
want to do
get refreshed then
and i'll see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter number 12
of this filter course
in this chapter and which i'm very
excited about we're going to talk about
a basic register screen well up until
this point we've been really configuring
our i mean if we go chronologically
we've had the introduction we've gone
through so many chapters to talk about
dart and its basics and even some more
advanced topics such as generics
and then as soon as we did that then we
basically
started learning about setting up our
iphone and android application also
after that
sorry the iphone and android application
together with certificates profiles and
got scr cpy working so there's been a
lot of information up on those till this
point so many hours of information that
you can go back and watch
and i strongly suggest that you actually
do that because i've explained
everything in such
extent extensive detail that i feel like
explaining all those things again and
again will be a waste of time both for
you and me
and
in this chapter
we are going to use all that information
that we've learned from the previous
chapters and start actually creating a
registration screen a simple
registration screen in our floater
application source code that talks with
firebase and firebase we set up in the
previous chapter if i'm not mistaken so
have a look at that chapter if you
haven't set up your firebase app
back-end
or at least i mean we haven't really set
up anything we've just like
well yeah actually set up yeah we could
say set up um but we haven't really
configured in such great details it's
just like we've set it up so
have a look at that chapter please if
you want to um
before you continue with this chapter so
so
i'm gonna go to my captions here and
just ensure that i can show you the
correct captions
now what we need to do in this chapter
is to start working on our registration
screen and what i'm going to do here is
bring up a caption for you so that you
know what we're going to do
the first thing you need to do is to
bring your
visual studio code
or your editor of choice
on the screen so i'm i'm going to do
that and then i'm going to bring my
android phone mirrored on the screen
with scrcpy
and then i'll see if i can bring my face
to the right so you can see a little bit
of a bigger screen
and what we need to do here now is to go
in this main dart file and remove
everything that is a comment now
if you're coming from like a design
background or a product owner or um like
in
wherever whatever background that is not
software development related if you're
coming from those backgrounds then you
may not know what a comment is however
i'll tell you now a comment is a piece
of information piece of text that is
written inside a source file such as
this main dart file that doesn't
translate to an actual code so it's
information placed there
usually for other developers or whoever
is looking at the code so that they
understand the code a little bit better
okay
comments in dart can be created in
different ways however the most
i mean the most usual way of doing it is
with
double forward slashes as you can see
here and a space and then some text all
right
so
i'm going to need you now to go into
your main dart file and we're going to
remove all these comments right now
because they are basically creating a
lot of noise for us right now okay
so let's go ahead and remove all those
gray lines or whatever color they're
displayed on your screen they may be
green
depending on your
theme
i have tokyo knight as i mentioned
before
in visual studio code so comments are
displayed in gray
gonna remove all that comment there okay
and that's it
so and i think this as well
and i don't know yeah and it seems also
like uh
so yeah i think now we've removed all
the comments so if i do command s that
does a hot
reload
and i'm actually going to talk about
what the hot reload is but if you've
done this then you're good to go i'm
going to take that in my notes so we've
talked about it
now the next topic to talk about here is
hot reload versus hot restart now
these two are so important for you to
understand that i think you should like
get this before you continue with the
rest of the course and i'm gonna do my
best to explain what hot reload and
hardware start are
if you're for instance coming from a
design background where you have for
instance figma
and you design your um
stuff you're you're putting some vectors
on the screen you're dragging images and
i can go in your figma design and
literally observe you as you're doing
that so i'm actually looking at your
changes you don't have to press any
publish button nothing like that even if
you're in your drafts i can still follow
you and watch you as you're designing
now that future is very very much
possible in flutter as well
however
the cost of doing that the same thing
that figma does is quite heavy because
as i'm changing my code i actually i'm
not going to be able to see my changes
unless i tell flutter that okay i've
made some changes show me them on the
screen
that is hot reload okay for instance if
i go in here and i say flutter demo home
page and remove the demo home page from
here
press command s that's going to save my
file which in turn is going to do a hot
reload okay
so command s
you can see this title now was changed
from here
so it's set it says not flutter demo i'm
going to change it back command s hot
reload and it's going to say home page
now you can also avoid for instance
doing command s and just go in here in
your visual studio code or android
studio and just say hot reload so i can
see now that didn't actually do it that
was great because i can see a little
like blob here you see the circle on
this file this in visual studio code is
an indicator of a file that has not been
saved so
so if i save it and it itself is going
to do a hot reload so i don't have to
actually manually press the hot reload
button so save and then you can see the
changes immediately applied there
however some changes to your code are
going to be so big that footwear is not
able to resolve the delta from the
previous state of the application to the
new states and we will come to those
changes very difficult to explain them
right now but just know that hot reload
is
usually works in 99 something percent
like i'm making up statistics here in
most cases hot reload works in that it
can show you your latest changes however
sometimes your changes may be so drastic
and so big and the
the
calculation of the delta from the
previous previous state to the next to
the new state may be so big that flutter
isn't able to do that so then you will
have to do hot reload and then hot
reload is
here sorry hot restart you will have to
do a hot restart sorry about that
so there's more differences between them
like internally about the state
like the state of your application and
whether one
keeps your state and the other one loses
your state so i'm not going to talk
about that right now because we haven't
even talked about states in flutter so i
don't think it makes so much sense to
talk about that right now just know that
in most cases hot reload displays your
latest changes and that and it's
sufficient if you just do a command s
and save your files
but hot restart it will basically kind
of like rebuild your application
with new states okay
so i think i think to be honest with you
that's sufficient for now
so what we need to do now
is to
have a look a little bit about at
restructuring the code that is created
for us by default
and as you can see here
um i mean we don't really know how these
things work right now
um you don't even know like in the
caption i say material app inside run
app and home page widget
what does this mean well you don't know
that and that's okay
i'm not going to like confuse us right
now with too much detail but what you'll
need to know right now is that
let's go in here and i'm gonna bring the
logs up
what i'm gonna do in here in this build
function of my app
just go and type print
building
okay
and command s and then you'll see that
printed to the screen so every time i'm
pressing command s
this entire application is being built
again and there is a little bit of like
a resource
hug because
as you can see here material application
is the entire
kind of like a scaffolding entire frame
of your application including the bar on
top including this white view here and
including that badge up there on the top
right
it's like you are pretty much building
things that you don't need to build
every time you save this file so it's a
little bit of like a a problem of um
performance whether you want to do that
or not but in this in this uh course i'm
just i'm gonna give you some advice on
how to make your application also run a
little bit faster so to do that what we
need to do is just to tell flutter that
hey look we don't want to build the
entire app every time
or the app structure every time we're
pressing command s to how to hot reload
so
your
challenge here now is to if i get rid of
this
what we need to do now is you can see
here
in the main function which is the root
function that flutter calls when it
actually runs your application it says
okay i'm running an app called my app
and if you look at my app the only thing
it does it actually creates a material
app that's all it does so
what you need to do now is to grab this
material app so i'm just going to say
command x on
mac
or control x i think on windows and
linux
grab that and instead of this const my
app
paste that in there okay
and then kill your my app boom like that
okay and then do command s
and just to make sure everything is
working correctly i'm just going to do a
hot restart
and you can see everything is working as
it should so what we did here really was
actually let's see my homepage yeah
that's fine
um
yeah so
what we have now is just the main
function and something called my
homepage stateful widget all right so
get your code also to this state
i'm gonna take in my notes that i've
talked about that all right
so the next thing we need to talk about
is stateless versus stateful
now
state
i mean for me it feels like for me to be
able to explain this i need to first
explain what a state is uh let's say in
here i press this button
five times okay
and then i go and i say oh i want to
change the title of this little label
there i'm gonna say you
you've instead of you have
or
yeah let's convert this to double quotes
because we're putting a single code in
there
i'm gonna say you've pushed the button
this many times and i'm gonna say
command s or control s in windows and
linux to hot reload
hot reload yeah command s okay
and you can see is that you've pushed
the button this many times but it kept
the number five
so if it rebuilt this application or
this widget
or this thing that you can see on the
screen how did it keep keep the state
well that is because
hot reload is able to sometimes as i
mentioned before keep your state and
state is just data data usually
mutated and created either by the
application or the user or both and in
this case this is a state that the user
is controlling so by pressing the button
he or she is increasing this number now
it's 10 okay
a state full widget it can keep that
information
so
it you see it has
something called a counter
it's an integer and it keeps hold of
that number so
and upon this number being changed it
can kind of redraw itself so
stateful widget is
something that is on the screen usually
something that you can visibly see
such as this screen the white screen you
can see here
stateful
and it can contain data
upon who's changing it can redraw itself
itself so
had we had the same widget as you can
see in my home page and it was stateless
widget which is available as well
you see
let's switch it
it wouldn't necessarily be able to
redraw itself or contain any mutable
data i mean even stateless widgets
for those who are a bit more familiar
with flutter you'll have like value not
notifier and builders so even stateless
widgets can be redrawn depending on what
you're trying to do
but they cannot contain
mutable variables so that is kind of
like the um
difference between stateful and
stateless so you can see here this is a
variable that is not read-only otherwise
it would be final so if i make this
final you can see it says oh you can't
reassign this value to something else so
just know that if you see state full
widget then it is a widget that contains
information that can be
changed
as the user interacts with the widget or
as time goes by or as the widget sees
fit however stateless widget is a widget
who's
who has who doesn't contain any mutable
pieces of information and doesn't manage
any mutable pieces of information
internally okay
that's a lot of just just there's a lot
of talk i know if you're not comfortable
with like if you if you haven't done
software development before you may not
this may not make any sense to you and i
promise you as we go on and of course
you're gonna learn more about it so
don't worry about it if you didn't get
this
on the get-go
so
you can see now let's see um
let's talk a little bit about i'm gonna
actually tick this
in the
in my in my notes
okay so i can see in my notes that i had
um
that as part of as part of uh
what i was going to explain here i was
actually
i had planned i can see my notes i had
planned in one of the previous captions
uh here um
as part of this caption i was actually
supposed to come completely kill this my
home page uh widget
and i was supposed to actually create a
widget just called home page so let's do
that let's just go back into that
caption so kill this my home page
and now
go in here and change this to home page
so what we need to do now is to create a
very simple home page okay so i'm gonna
remove this title from here as well and
you can see now we have an error telling
us that okay i don't know what home page
is now what we need to do is to create a
uh actually let me see if i plan to
create a stateless yeah stateless widget
okay
a great shortcut that you need to know
in visual studio code and i think it may
be available in android studio as well
is if you want to create a stateless
widget just type stl
and you can see it tells you that okay
you want to create a stateless widget
great
okay there it is then you give it the
name of home page okay so now you have a
home page great and i'm going to do a
command s and now you can see this is
one of the times that flutter was like
okay
i don't understand what you're trying to
do you change some stuff in this main
function and i can't do hot reload so
you have to do hot restart so now the
screen is kind of gonna be black
so
now we have what i had planned in the
course initially for for this chapter so
great let's go now to the next point
um
so you can see the screen is black here
and that's because of this container
there is a little container there or
something on the screen that you can't
really see because it's just black so
you could go in here and say there is a
color and you can say colors red i just
command s
and you can see now the screen is red so
just know that there is something on the
screen but you just can't see it because
it's all black so
the way to get your application to a
point that is actually like presentable
to a user you usually have to create
something called a scaffold now scaffold
as it as its name indicates it's kind of
just like the basic building structures
of an application that kind of makes it
presentable to a user to an average user
so
even though if you're creating like a
graphically intensive application this
black background may be completely okay
but in most applications when you run
them then you'll get
then you'll get like a bar on top that
tells you like the name of the screen
that you're on kind of like the title of
a web page and you'll also get some like
a status bar on top where as you can see
here the status bar is kind of like
black with all white icons on top and it
will give you like a wide screen where
you can interact with your content
so we don't have that and in order to
create that you have to create something
called a scaffold so
go to your container here and say
scaffold okay
now i'm gonna press command s and you'll
see all this on then we get this little
white screen here and then there's a
little tint on our status bar as well so
it makes it a little bit more
presentable okay
so
what we need to do now i'll basically
see if i've planned to add some bar
title in here which i haven't so let's
do that right now so for our scaffold
we're also going to add an is something
called an app bar
so go to your scaffold and say app bar
and then say i create a new instance of
the app bar class all right
and in here there's a property called
title and as the title say text
okay
and for the text i'm going to get rid of
all this documentation there's excessive
amount of documentation here which kind
of blocks the screen so
and for the text just say
register
for instance and make it a constant
so and put a comma here and a
uh comma here as well
so you see after you've done that
your screen has a beautiful blue bar
here with the title of your uh
application or the title of your home
page
and there is a white canvas here for the
rest of your content to be displayed so
now there are a few things in here which
i could jump over but i kind of feel
like they're so important to explain
that i'm going to do that right now so
in flutter every time you have for
instance here there is a text you see
sorry there is an app bar an app bar if
you go into the source code of an app
bar let's go a little bit higher you can
see it it says i'm a stateful widget all
right so app bar in itself is a widget
so what we're doing here is saying we
have something called a scaffold let's
go to scaffold it itself is a stateful
widget so we're saying the main widget
we're returning from our build function
as you can see it should return a widget
is a scaffold which is a stateful widget
in itself it has a property called app
bar an app bar it itself is a stateful
widget which in turn has a property
called title now the title
if you look at the documentation it says
title is also widget
so
let me also make the screen a little bit
bigger
like this so you see it better
so
now the title is a widget and we're
saying oh we're going to use a text
widget if you look at text what it is is
a stateless widget it means internally
it states or its state can change and it
it doesn't have any mutable variables
okay oh i didn't want to change that
so
if you see what we're doing here when in
flutter you're just creating widgets
everywhere in flutter almost everything
is a widget either stateful or stateless
and you try to you need to kind of try
to stick to stateless widgets as much as
you can all right we're going to talk
more about stateful and stateless so
now that we've added the scaffold and
i've explained a little bit about these
widgets that were we've created and
we've done a command as here just to
hot reload the application or this
widget
uh what we need to do next is to create
a login button
so
let's go and create some sort of a login
button
and you can see here i've written the
caption button on home page in the
center to log in
or more accurately it could actually be
register
so i'm going to change that i'm going to
say register button
and button on the homepage in the center
to register okay
display the caption to you there
to and i'm gonna change my notes here
just quickly all right so
now your task is to create a button on
the screen how do you do that well
in scaffold you see the scaffold at the
moment it's the owner of that bar on top
and it's the owner of this
white content here so what you need to
do is to go and look at a property
called body
and body is
in itself if i move my mouse over it
says okay give me a widget you see
and of course i could say well i have no
widgets null is also acceptable but in
this case we're going to create a button
called text button so text button is a
widget if you go into source code you'll
see it's a
text button button style button and that
is a state full widget all right so
you're basically saying that i'm
creating a button and i want to allow
the user to do something with it all
right so we need to do as you can see
there is a little bit of an error here
to say that says unpressed is a
parameter that you haven't provided to
me so we need to tell this button
that
when this button is pressed it needs to
do something and this is a requirement
for the text button class that it's
telling you well i'm a button
what do you want me to do when i'm
pressed if you don't press if you don't
provide unpressed parameter to me i
don't i'm not even a button i could just
be a label and that is what this error
is all about is saying that if you're
creating a button make sure that you
handle
what happens when the user presses on so
in here just type unpressed
and i'm just going to get visual studio
to complete this code for me you can see
it says okay an empty function
a function with empty list of parameters
so no parameters
and then
the code in itself is empty at the
moment okay so go after the create
creation of that function and then you
see that there is another that you have
to handle that says child
you see text button you would say you
would probably just assume that oh a
text button should have some sort of a
string parameter that says what is my
text
so
if we write child here the beauty of
flutter is that it says
child is a widget so text button doesn't
doesn't make any assumptions about what
content you want to display on that
button
what it does it says i need to display
some widget anything it could be an
image it could be an icon it could be
whatever it could be a list of things
which is not a good idea to do but you
could still do that so
um
go and create a child widget and now
you've learned about the text widget so
i'm just gonna say a constant text
widget and in here we're just going to
say register okay
now command s
and you'll see now all of a sudden you
have a register button there
so another cool feature now i want to
show you in visual studio and i think
it's available also in android stu is
that you can go and wrap your widgets
with other widgets so instead of for
instance saying that i want the text
button to be in the center and then you
go and create a center if
you know it also exists you could do
command dot or command dot on mac or
control dot in windows and linux and
visual studio code on the widget that
you want to wrap in some other widget
and then
you will get this beautiful menu that
says you you know you can wrap it with
many different things so i'm just going
to pronounce a wrap with center so as
you can see center is a widget that has
a child property all center does is that
it tries to center
horizontally and vertically it's child
inside the available space of the center
widget itself
the entire available space in this case
as you can see is this entire white
background so center has access to that
entire white background right now
because center is the root widget of our
body which is the only thing that our
scaffold is showing at the moment
so
center then is able to center align this
text button so let's command s and you
can see the register button is centered
horizontally and vertically in the
available space
now that i've talked about that i'm
going to take it here
and what we're going to do here is very
very important so
what we need to do is
we now need to handle when the text
button is pressed
that we're going register a user with
firebase okay
now
we talked about this when i talked about
like uh dart in the previous chapters we
talked about synchronous and
asynchronous and i'm not gonna go into
details about that now
registration i'm sorry i'm not going to
talk about that in details because we've
talked about that in details before so
if you need to know about that i think
synchronous and asynchronous were
probably explained in um i'll have a
look at my notes
they were explained in chapter number
seven so if you haven't watched chapter
number seven i strongly suggest that you
do that if you don't know what sync and
async are
um
what we need to do now is to tell
firebase to register user now
registering a user with firebase is an
asynchronous task so it's not going to
complete immediately so what we need to
do now is to tell flutter that the
button press is an asynchronous task and
all you need to do here is just to put
the keyword async in there okay
so
that is that
that's it in my
notes i've talked about it
now
what we need to do is to have a look at
this link that i've provided for you
um i'm going to close this safari window
let me see if i can
show you on this screen
um
other sign-in methods great you can see
as i'm displaying here
firebase allows you to
enable various sign-in methods
uh to your for your users so
um
firebase
is not only limited to like google
services you can as you can see it can
allow you to enable facebook signing for
users or apple sign-in
twitter or phone number sign-in so there
are various methods available
for you to enable in your flutter
application and in this application
we're gonna use email and password sign
in
and there's like documentation about all
of those in this link that i've provided
provided to you so
i'm not gonna go through the entire
contents of this to be honest with you
because there are just so much
information and we're not interested in
all of these but still i believe if
you're interested in firebase and
firebase authentication which we are
going to use in this course it is great
if you could just have a look at this
link that i provided for you here
so
what we need to do now
is also right i've written here that i
need to talk about a little bit about
anonymous users you see firebase when
you start your application and you kick
firebait if firebase
you basically start the whole process of
firebase you say firebase start
firebase is amazing in that on the
client side it by default creates
something called an anonymous user so if
you talk with firebase with your
thoughts or application and say who's
the current user even if you haven't
done anything with firebase before if
you haven't configured it or actually
you have to configure it
which we have already done but if you
haven't called any firebase functions
before in your application you could
just say firebase who's the current user
and firebase will just tell you here's a
current user it's an anonymous user so
that user is pretty much never going to
be empty it's never going to be null or
nil or whatever you like to call it so
or if you're python developer you just
call it none so that user is almost
never none
so just know that firebase has a concept
of anonymous users okay
i'm just going to take that in my notes
that we've talked about it
so what we need to do in the next step
i'm going to bring the caption up so we
have to kind of like speed things up a
little bit here because there's so much
to talk about
um what we need to do here now is just
to
create two text fields now one for the
email and the other one for the password
and we are going to then put our button
um
next to those two text fields so text
field one email text field 2 password
and then the register button as the
third component now if you have
components like this that you want to
stack vertically one on top of each
other and one after each other then you
need to use a which is called column all
right
so what i'm going to do here is go here
to the center and kind of like remove
that i'm just going to say command dot
in mac or control dot in windows on
linux and just say remove this widget
okay i don't want to center anymore
command s results register buttons on
top left and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to command up again and say wrap
with column okay now if you command s
you'll not see anything directly on the
screen no changes all right
but what was created for you is a column
widget with children property which is a
list of widgets that it can display so
the first thing we're gonna do is to
create two text fields okay
so let me have a look here and just make
sure yeah
i'm just going to say a text field
and another text field okay
like that
save you'll see two text fields display
there so i can actually go in there and
start typing something okay
like that so now we've created two text
fields with a column
on the screen
i'm going to note that here a ticket in
my notes so we've talked about it now
what we need to do is
grab the text that is displayed in this
take these text fields and when you
press the register button pass that to
firebase okay now you see i'm telling
you that when you press the button you
need to grab the text inside these text
fields but inside this function of
onpress you have no access to these text
fields okay so you kind of need to pass
information from this text field and
this text field to a text button and the
way to do that is is using something
called a text controller
so
a text or a text editing controller a
text editing controller is kind of like
a proxy object that you pass
to your text field and the text field it
writes its current text all the time to
that text editing controller and in your
text button here then you can say
controller text okay so you can then so
it's kind of like if your text field is
sitting here and your text button is
sitting here then you'll have something
here in the middle that is your proxy
the text editing controller that is
grabbing me for latest information from
the text field and then your the text
button can read that information okay so
just know that a text editing controller
is kind of like a proxy
now that we need to manage some state we
need to manage this proxy object then we
need to convert our home page to a
stateful widget okay so go in here to
your home page command dot and say
convert to stateful widgets so all of a
sudden stateful widget all right
so
um now what we need to do is to go and
create those two text editing
controllers so i'm going to go in here
go to your home page state
here and say
late final
what do we call them do i have any
specific desire here let me see my notes
no
so there's no desire really for the
naming so let's just say late final text
thing
controller and let's call it here email
okay
and the other one i'm just gonna
say password
now in the previous chapters we haven't
talked about late what late is this
keyword in dark that tells your program
that although this print although this
variable has no value right now but i
promise to assign a value to it before
it is used so it's kind of like a it's a
contract so
late literally means that i'm not ready
right now i will do it later i'm not
ready to assign a value to this so
what we need to do now is to
um
is to create these values now
you need to also know something about
stateful widgets now that our homepage
state is a stateful widget it will have
two amazing
amazing two great
functions one is called init state i
believe and the other one called is
disposed now init state is a function
that will be called by flutter
automatically when it creates your home
page so it says okay now you have the
ability to create all your variables or
your late variables
once
now whenever this homepage then dies and
goes out of the memory or it's trying to
go out the memory it will also get a
function called dispose
so
you've said that in the contract i've
written that i'm going to provide a
value for these emails email and
password text editing controllers and
the best way to do that is to go into
this init state
function here
and
assign those to proper values so i'm
just gonna say email
email is text editing controller like
that
okay
and i'm gonna do the same thing for the
password field
now you also need to understand that you
after you've created these two you also
need to dispose of them all right so
go in and overwrite your dispose
function
and then say email dispose and password
so a lot of developers forget to do this
especially like newcomers so don't make
that mistake so you created the text
editing controllers and you're also in
charge of disposing them okay
now um
okay uh so we've done that already
after you've created your text editing
controllers you need to go to your text
fields and assign
those controllers to your text field so
in here there's a parameter called
controller and just say email
and for your text field on the second
one which is for your password say
controller
it's password so what is happening now
is you hooked this proxy object that sat
here
this one which is your email or password
text editing controller to your text
field that is sitting here okay you
still haven't hooked it to your text
button which is sitting here so this
link is kind of broken and we're gonna
fix that soon
okay take it in the notes that we've
talked about that
so what we need to do now at the moment
if i press command s you will see no
visible changes on the screen however
there's a little bit of a problem with
our text fields as you can see they
don't have any hint they don't tell the
user what they expect the user to
actually enter so
what we need to do now is to go and add
something to these text fields called a
hint
a hint is a piece of information
provided to the user
and usually kind of like very subtle
color that tells the user about the
information that this text field expects
them to enter
and that hint will automatically be
removed as soon as the user types at
least one character on that text field
okay so let's go to the first text field
and say
decoration
and i believe it's an input decoration
and then say input decoration okay
and for the hint there's so much
information on the screen we can't see
anything
and there is a hint text as you can see
hints text and it expects a string so in
here say please enter or just say enter
your email here
and you can see it's suggesting this to
be a constant so i'm going to make it a
constant
and a little bit of a comma there as
well and you can see now it says enter
your email here
and copy and paste this decoration as
well and put it in the next text field
so say that enter your password
here
so let's enter your email here enter
your password here
so
um
let me also make sure that that is
correct there and take it in the box so
um
then if you start typing in those fields
you can see that the hints disappears as
soon as you type something and if you
remove that character then the hint also
disappears and the same thing for the
password okay
so we've now got the
groundwork like the base
work done here and we need to get
through the authentication so when you
press this text button here where we
need to do authentication and that means
we're just going to register for now
so what you need to do is you need to
import
firebase so firebase was our dependency
and using the import statement you can
actually grab the content that it was
created for firebase and bring it into
your source code okay
so as you can see here we're gonna bring
package uh firebase off
and firebase off parts okay
now command s you don't see any
difference on the screen because an
import statement doesn't really change
the state of your application as such
and after
the importing
we need to
i'm going to take it here as well that
we've talked about it
so what we need to do now is to upon
pressing this button where we're going
to get your
username and password from these text
fields so let's say final
username or sorry email and i'm going to
say the email field text
i'm going to say final password
is password
text
we're going to our email and password
controllers and grabbing their text
which is the latest text that the user
entered in those fields okay
so
after we've done that now you can go and
say firebase
auth
instance
and then you will say create user with
email and password you can see this is a
function
that allows you to register or create a
user as its name indicates uh with
firebase so
um i'm gonna do that so as you can see
here as well this thing returns a future
okay so
um
so this is this is not nothing that you
can just like call and say hey do this
now
um
without actually awaiting on it
otherwise it will just say here i am a
future i'm something that i will
calculate something in the future and
by not putting a weight before that call
you will only get the instance of future
you will not actually get the work that
it's doing you will get like a wrapper
around the work saying that this is the
kind of work i'm gonna do but if you
have weight on it it will actually
perform the work
if that makes any sense so i've
explained the weight in that chapter i
think also chapter seven or whatever it
was when we talked about more advanced
topics in dart so please have a look at
that chapter as well
um after doing that you will see that
the return of this is actually future of
a user credential so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to say final user
credential is this
and then i'm going to print it user
credential okay
so command s
and just hot restart here just in case
because we didn't import so what i'm
going to do in enter email here i'm
going to say pixelityab.gmail.com
and for the password i'm just going to
say fubar
bass okay
so let's bring our console up so we can
see what our application prints to the
screen
and i'm just going to say register which
we're going to get an error for right
now so
and you can see here it says no firebase
app default has been created called
firebase initialize app
so
this is i mean this is really good that
we're getting this because i actually
have planned for us to fix that
um but before we go ahead and do that
um i should probably explain what this
is why this is happening you see
firebase there was there was if you
remember when we configured it there was
a file created here for us called
firebase options
and it has a lot of code in it and then
there's like a configuration here uh
that here you see android and for ios as
well now what firebase is complaining
about is saying that you've created this
configuration but you've never actually
told me about it so
poor firebase so what we need to do now
before we actually do the configuration
is to fix
something that you can immediately see
on the screen which is which is
incorrect
you see foo bar bas is your password it
shouldn't be visible to the user so when
you're typing it it should be a password
field and at the same time this field
here you see is is an email field but
where is the add sign at sign isn't
immediately visible here so you need to
tell these text fields to be configured
in a specific way so that they're
actually suitable for email and password
registration fields
so i'm going to get rid of this bar on
the right oh sorry on the left
and what we need to do is to bring up
the caption
for the next thing for the next topic to
talk about talk about
first what we're going to do is to make
this
password text field
secure
so
what you need to do here in your
decoration of the password field go in
here and say obscure um actually it's
not in the decorations right here
obscure text
it has true and if you press s on that
you'll see that your text is now obscure
also you need to do a
enable suggestions
false and then you will also do
autocorrect
false these are three important
properties to
provide here now you see enable
suggestions is usually like as you're
typing in a text field depending on your
operating system
it will provide you suggestions like
this
in a password field you don't want to do
that you don't want to have any
suggestions so that's for enabled
suggestions also autocorrect is when you
try to type something and you know you
all probably know what autocorrect is so
i'm not going to explain it so you're
disabling autocorrect based on your
password password field which makes
sense so um now
let's go and bring these two properties
also to our email field which is
here
okay
and what we're also going to do is to
tell it that it is an email it needs an
email keyboard so let's go in here and
say input
or keyboard i think type and it's called
text
input type i think
and then dot email
there's the email address so
save it
now if i then go here you can see
there's an ad sign so i can um oh sorry
you can't see it so i'm going to do
this so you can actually see the that
sign so you can see their keyboard here
and then there's an ad sign right there
okay
so
that's for that and then suggestions are
also disabled so as i type there's no
suggestions really for my um text
because you don't want suggestions on
email fields emails are usually like
crazy texts so
um or not usually but sometimes so you
don't want any suggestions there okay
we've done that i wanna take all of
these items as done in in my notes
now the next thing we need to do
is uh to fix that uh
initialization of our firebase app so
we're gonna do it naively right now so
i'm going to go
because you see we still have this error
so if i if i bring this up
clean the
errors and then say
pixelity a b gmail.com and i say
ubar baz
i say register we will still get this
error that says no if no firebase app is
configured okay
so what we need to do is to actually
register
sorry initialize firebase before we do
firebase instance create user with email
and password
so
what we need to do then is to go here
and say firebase
initialize firebase
app
see what we have there
firebase
auth instance or initialize app
i've actually forgotten the syntax for
that so
let's see if we actually can learn
how to do that by going to our
um
firebase options
initialize you can see it should be done
like this
and what we need to do then is to import
firebase options as it's as it's showing
here firebase options and then await
firebase.initialize app with this okay
so let's let's kind of grab that code
and then go into our main guard file and
import firebase options so i'm going to
go here and say import
firebase options
and right before we
do the
registration here
i'm gonna do
this code that was provided there for us
so i'm gonna remove the comments
command s and i can still see that
firebase isn't imported so we're going
to import it by doing import library
package firebase core firebase core here
what i did here is that i basically took
advantage something that's built into
visual studio code in order for me to
get the import statement automatically
so i'm going to do command dot on it and
it says okay
import this dart file so i'm just gonna
take advantage of that why not
and you can see that it is imported here
firebase core
so
now that we've done that um i'm gonna
press command s my state is preserved in
the uh in my phone here and let me bring
the logs here clean them and then i'm
gonna press the register button
boom
uh here and we got an error here and it
says device unlock initializing all
firebase apis and firebase preparing to
create blah blah and let's actually see
what the error was so
it is on handle exception request
failed
and
unreachable host and that is probably
because i actually don't have proper
internet connection on my
phone
here
so i'm gonna go here and i'm gonna go to
settings
actually great that you're seeing these
errors because these things do happen so
and i'm gonna turn wi-fi on
so make sure that it's gonna connect to
a valid wi-fi
here
and it connected i'm gonna go back to
the application
clear the logs oh my god there are so
many things displayed there
so then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
repeat the same thing i'm gonna say
register now
so
now we got to the
next state that i have prepared that it
says you can see in the errors it says
configuration not found now
what is happening here i'm not taking my
notes that we've talked about the other
part of the code
what is happening here is that
we haven't actually told firebase
that we are going to take advantage of
email and password signing combination
as i told you before there are various
way for various ways for a firebase to
allow us to register a user uh apple
login um you can do email and password
combination you can do facebook you can
do google
maybe twitter as well yeah i think
twitter was there as well so you need to
tell firebase that um
we basically want to
allow this combination all right
so
now i've explained that let's bring up
safari or your favorite browser maybe
chrome and let's go to uh console
firebase google.com i'm going to bring
my browser on the screen so you can also
see it
and i'm going to then find our
application which was called
uh my notes flutter project okay so go
to
consolefirebase.google.com and find your
project that you created in the previous
chapter click on it
then go to authentication as i as i show
you here
and let's see
uh
authentication actually get started
and in sign in
uh what we need is this email and
password combination so go email and
password combination and just allow it
all right
so and then press save
and that's it that's all you have to do
so i'm gonna
grab this screen just kind of bring it
to another
monitor so you don't see it clean the
logs and then say register
so you can see now all of a sudden you
got user credentials back from firebase
so
you actually could now um
register your application like register
a real user with firebase like that is
actually magical so i'm gonna
click on my notes that i've talked about
that
so
however you see this this is a little
bit problematic in that by pressing the
button but we're actually initializing
an application and then we're doing the
create user with email and password what
would happen if you had two or three
buttons on the screen all needing
firebase you can't do firebase
initialize app in every single one of
them so the solution to this is kind of
like initializing your firebase
application before you
start and start with everything else in
your in your on your screen and on your
phone so
there is good documentation of how to do
that and i've actually linked to that so
i'm going to bring it here
so what we need to do is take advantage
of something called widgets flutter
binding
and
what happens to be honest with you here
is that firebase it needs some
it needs to
kick start its process before everything
else is rendered on the screen and in
order for that to happen it needs to it
needs to have some sort of that like the
core flutter engine to be in place
and so that it can make its call to the
core slaughter engine and say that i'm
done with my work so in order to do that
then you need something called um
widgets flutter binding
so i'm gonna
i'm gonna bring up
the um caption for that and i can show
you that i'm this is this is the
documentation that i'm showing you as of
linked there
so
in our in your void function here
um before we actually you see
maybe i'm jumping over a little bit but
what we're trying to do is to try to fix
this issue here that we're awaiting on
initialize app on firebase okay so we
don't want to do this on the press of a
button we actually want to do it
somewhere else and in order to be able
to do that somewhere else we have to
first take care of this widget binding
okay so in your main function in here
then say um
i think we need to say
widgets flutter binding dot ensure
initialized like that
okay and if you want to know more about
that i strongly suggest that you read
this documentation that i've provided
here okay
so now that that is in place
um now that you've done that do a hot
restart
okay so you're gonna lose your state
here after the hot restart and that's
okay
i'm gonna take that in my notes that
i've talked about that
now
as you know this initialize
app is a future you see it's a future of
firebase app now what you need to do is
kind of like you want to tell flutter to
not build this column before it has
finished doing that future
and
the way to do that is using flutter's
future builder widget future builder it
takes a future
it performs the future and once this
future has succeeded or it has failed
doing its work it will give you a call
back and in that callback it asks you to
actually produce a widget you want to
display to the user depending on the
state
of that futures result so it basically
instead of you having to do this
initialization of firebase every time a
user presses the button you say i'm not
going to do anything until that is done
once that is done or if it errors out
let me know then i will give you a
widget to display to the user depending
on the results okay
so what we're gonna do
is gonna go to this body which is a
column right now command dot and then
let's see stream builder we have but we
don't have future builder so i'm just
gonna say command dot wrap with
widget
and i'm gonna say future builder okay so
i'm gonna build a future as you can see
it says
okay builder is required so let's put a
builder parameter here and if you're
like me and you forget these syntaxes
you can just control space in visual
studio code on mac or command space in
linux and windows to get help
and then you'll just use this syntax
there okay
so bring your entire column
here you see this until the end of the
column without the comma
then you remove your child bring that
entire thing and put a return here and
just place it there okay
like that
now your future builder um it doesn't
have an actual future to come to perform
so
for its future
let's see i wanna
say that we've talked about the future
builder
and what we need to do now is to grab
this future from here you see
await firebase initialize app and grab
that future without the weight remove
the weight
and put it in the future builders future
parameter
like that
all right
command s
on a hot restart
and
you can see nothing has really happened
on the screen so
you didn't have any difference you don't
notice any difference basically
so if everything really worked as it
should
um
then what we need to do then is to
um if everything is working as expected
then we should be able to register users
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to provide the exact same user
already registered and then say register
and you'll see now we get an error
let's see if i can show you there and it
says the error is firebase auth email
already in use the email or the email
address is already in use by another
account
and that is this part which i'm gonna
bring the caption up for you
so
we've also talked about that
all right
so
the next topic that i want to talk about
before we close off and round off this
uh chapter
is connection states you see
we told future builder to perform a
future
the future was firebase initialize app
okay this thing
now if you look at the builder what
we're returning from it right now is a
column but we're completely ignoring the
parameters that are coming in here
the second parameter that gets passed
your builder is something called a
snapshot of data type async snapshot as
you can see there
an async snapshot of an object is the
state of that object right now okay
so and that object itself is actually
the result of your future in this case
firebase app so
it's just that
it didn't understand that this snapshot
is an async snapshot of your firebase
app but that's okay we don't actually
need the firebase app in the snapshot
however one thing that you do need in
this snapshot is its state you see a
future has a start point it has a line
where it processes its information and
it has an end point it either ends
successfully or it fails now the
snapshot is your way of getting the
results of your future whether it
has it started is it processing is it
done or did it fail so what we need to
do in here as we're waiting for firebase
initialize app to do its work we're
gonna basically say uh we're loading
just tell the user loading and as soon
as the snapshot is done then we're gonna
say that
loading has finished
so let's do that let's go in here and
say
switch
snapshot
i believe it's called
connection state all right and then get
help from visual studio code to complete
this so i'm going to say add missing
case clauses and you can see there are
so many different cases
right
done waiting active and done
all right so
for
none
waiting let's let's just say everything
else except for done we're gonna return
like a
text that just says loading so
let's say in here we remove all of these
okay
in the done statement we say return this
entire column
all the way here
right and then we don't need the break
because we said return and then we're
going to say default
default is a special case which is not
actually inside that enumeration but is
a case that says everything else that i
haven't handled and in this case we just
say return text
loading something like this as a
constant okay
so i'm gonna heart reload
sorry hot restart and the two hours
video this is happening so fast that
we're not actually seeing the loading
but at least we have handled the case
that if for instance a user's connection
is too slow or their device is too slow
when the future has finished they will
see this column i'm gonna actually fold
it
and if this feature hasn't finished yet
it's not done then they will see this
text offloading all right and by the way
this is how you can actually fold and
unfold things in visual studio code so
fold
fold like this unfold all right it's a
great way of seeing more of your code so
wow a lot of information this this video
took an hour kind of like as i expected
um
so we now have a basic firebase setup
we've done our initialization of the
application of our firebase we talked
about a lot of widgets actually we
talked about column
column we text talked about text future
builder
text field
container
god app bar so many things so
this is a lot of content and if you
didn't get all of it that's okay we're
gonna talk more about these in the
upcoming chapters
but i strongly suggest that i mean if
you're watching this course and if
you're just watching it
and
if you're an advanced developer and
you're watching that's completely fine
but if you're if you're develop if
you're not a developer or if you're a
junior developer or someone who
doesn't have so much experience with
flutter development and you're really
trying to learn everything i'm saying
here please don't just watch this video
go and do this yourself go and write
this code pause the video as i'm talking
i know i'll talk a little bit fast but
that's just to save a little bit of time
pause the video write the code as i
write it test it as i test it and see
the results for yourself because that's
how you will learn not just by watching
so
great we've talked a lot about
widgets and firebase configuration
and in the next chapter we're going to
talk about login screen and also email
verification and also clean up our
registration screen so without further
ado let's just prepare yourself for the
next chapter and i'll see you there
hello and welcome to chapter 13 of this
flutter course
in this chapter we're going to talk
about the login view in chapter
12 as i can see here
sorry about that we talked about the
registration flow and
we actually talked about quite a lot of
things which after after that i i
thought maybe we need to kind of like go
through them one more time just
every now and then talk about those
those little widgets that we talked
about like a future builder center
column text button and we talked also
about um
text field text editing controller so
there were lots of components that we
talked about but we got pretty much like
a
a simple registration flow working it
wasn't really a flow actually it was
just a simple registration screen
i'm saying that it wasn't a flow because
it was just a simple screen that didn't
lean anywhere that's usually what is
called the flow if you have a screen
that leads somewhere
now in this chapter we're going to talk
about login the login view and we're
also going to divide the logic that
we've created in our current home page
and put it into a registration view so
we're by the end of this chapter we're
gonna have two views one is for the
registration the other one is for
the login okay
so as i've shown you here
um we have those logic i mean the
registration logic in place now we have
to work on login but we also work a
little bit on cleaning up the code
because
usually this i mean as you get more and
more comfortable with software
development you'll know that
you will have like these flows of ideas
and then you'll start coding and write
your code and then you test it and then
after a while you realize oh this got a
little bit messy i have to refactor the
code so that's what refactoring kind of
means like you take what is already
there and you kind of make it better
make it cleaner more presentable so
that's what we're also going to do in
this chapter
so the first thing we need to do is to
create a stateful register view widget
okay
so as you can see here this will be used
as
the base of our register view
so
let me go and bring some stuff that
we're going to need in this chapter the
first one is my scr
i bring it to the screen so you'll see
it as well
and scr cpy we set it up in one of the
previous chapters so you should be
comfortable with that already
um
i'm going to go to go to our app here
which is the register view that we
created gonna bring my face to the right
so we'll see a bit more of the content
on the screen
and then i'm also going to bring up
visual studio code which is appearing on
another screen right now but i'll bring
it up here so you'll see as well
i'm going to increase the size a little
bit as well so it becomes
easier to see
so this is where we lift things um
let me bring up
and do the screen like this so this is
where we live things we have a home page
which at the moment is the register view
okay but we need to create a register
view like not just a home page it's
called the home page so
and since we need a stateful widget
we're going to use a shortcut in visual
studio code to create a stateful widget
for us and that is with s t f as in
state full so if you want to create a
stateless widget you'd say stl okay
so stf
and in here we're going to call it what
should we say register view like that
all right
so
this will be as i've mentioned here this
will be the base
of our
this will be the base of our
registration view all the code for
register will
appear here i'm sorry that i'm looking
here just to make sure
that i'm basically
going through my notes i have very
detailed notes here and just making sure
that you get all the information that i
plan for you to get so if you see me
looking here it's just because i'm
looking at the notes to ensure that
um so now that we've created register
view at the moment it doesn't have
anything so it's just a container and
the default color for containers and
background is black so
let's go to our register view here
so let's go to our main function here
and as you can see at the moment we're
returning home page as the home and what
we're going to do here is just to say
instead of that return register view
okay
and that is it's very possible we will
get a problem here and you can see
nothing is changing because i'm changing
something inside the main and that isn't
affected really by a hot reload
so we have to hot restart so i'm gonna
go how to restart here
and you can see now the screen is black
so
um
that part is basically done
so what we'll have to do here now is to
rename our home page to our login view
actually so we have a new registration
view which we're going to write the code
for or actually place the code from the
previous home page into register view
and we also need the home page to be
renamed so it's very some i mean there's
lots of renaming putting things here and
there but we're just playing with some
names basically here so
the next thing you need to do is to go
to your home page which is here
and rename it one way to do that visual
studio code is to right click on it and
just say rename symbol or i believe it's
also
command f2
or actually for me it's f2 if two does
the renaming but on a macbook pro for
instance you don't you can't just press
f2 because f2 has another function
so what you'll need to do is to press
function keyboard keep key on your
keyboard and then press f2 that will
bring up the rename dialog or you could
just right click here and just say
rename symbol which does the same thing
so rename your home page to login view
okay
all right so we have login view here now
um i'm gonna take it that we've done the
rename
um you see
right now all we've been doing here is
just to like write our code write
everything in main dart but this is this
is not a not the right way of doing
things especially as your projects get
bigger you need to make sure that you're
you're taking the responsibility to also
make sure that your code is readable and
the structure of your project is
understandable by others who may also be
working on the same project now chances
are that if you're watching this course
that you will be the only person working
on the source code so you won't have
anybody else looking at your code
even though
that you may be the only person looking
at the code and working with it you
still will need to from time and time
come back to the project fix some stuff
add some stuff remove some stuff so
even if you're the only person working
with it you will need a clean
source code to look at so if you come
back to the source code after a month
and you start to add more and more stuff
to this main dart file after a while it
will just get out of control so
you'll need to also do refactoring on
your code just to ensure that it is in a
clean state so
what we're going to do is to bring up
our project browser here
as you can see we're inside lib and then
there's a file called main dart
what we need to do here is
to move our login view into its own file
and you can see here i've written that
we're going to move it into lib views
login view this file doesn't exist at
the moment so you'll need to create it
what you'll do here i mean in visual
studio code there's a great trick that
you can do that it can create a file on
all the intermediate
folders as well so instead of going here
and say new folder to create this views
folder and then inside there i create a
login view what you'll need to do just
say new file
and then type the entire path in there
so just say
views and then slash login view dot dart
and this will create the views folder
for you so it's great
um
so what i'll need to do here is to
take our login views code as you can see
here
as we had here class login view and then
bring all that code into this new login
view file that we just created okay so
i'm gonna get this out of the way
here and just
paste it
all right and that's okay we're getting
a lot of errors here and the reason
behind that is i mean we haven't talked
about import statements so much before
but import statement is
a way for you as a programmer to bring
in code written by others
whether it is the flutter team at google
or whether it is a third party
third-party dependency
and tell your
flutter
project
where those pieces of code are and at
the moment
i mean if you're not coming from a
software engineering background you're
not familiar with imports
this is um i mean
the closest analogy that i can find is
as if for instance in figma you've
created
um
you're trying to create an instance of a
design that you've already created but
figment doesn't know where that instance
is so you'll say oh here's a copy of the
button instance
and then figma is like oh where can i
find that button you haven't even
created it so then you need to first go
create that button or drag it in from
another project and put it in your
components
page and then you can create an instance
of it so
if you're not into design and
figma you may not understand what i just
said but
what i'm trying to do is just to be as
inclusive as possible in this course to
make sure anybody who's following this
course will
try to at least understand bits and
pieces of what i'm saying
so
going back to import what we need to do
now is to tell flutter where those
pieces of highlighted code are and one
thing to do in visual studio code which
can help you greatly if you're trying to
go around this
writing things by hand is just to do
command on mac or control on linux and
windows hold down command or control
depending on your operating system and
press dot
then you will see suggestions here as
where those components those missing
components may be placed and what you'll
need to do here is just to import
package flutter material because that's
where these components that we're using
are actually placed so oops
i managed to click the wrong wrong
option there so material boom
all right i think now almost everything
has disappeared all almost every error
has disappeared except for these
firebase errors so
let's go and
let's see
so let's go
in there
and say now firebase core
import that
and also here we need to import minors
firebase options okay
so i think everything basically is
disappeared there's also firebase auth
import that as well
alright so we're good to go now on this
login view however remember
this login views code really is not
login view i mean if you remember the
code that we've written in the previous
chapter
this login view at the moment it says
log view but all it does is register do
you remember that we have the text field
and even the button that says register
so
what we need to do now is to
drag the code as you can see here from
the login view here
we need to kind of bring it into the
register view okay and our register view
at the moment is here you see
there
so let's go and try to do that a little
bit with care okay so grab all this code
that is here in the login view here
there
get dispose in its state
and also grab your email and password
and member variables
from here and
cut them
so i'm gonna go then in here in the
register view state
then paste those right before the build
function so there we go okay
go back to login view dart and you can
see that there is a build function here
here
and
i'm going to literally just grab that
entire build function including the
override
and
as i can see here the build function
ends right there and i'm gonna cut that
also okay and i'm gonna go here and
replace this override on the um
on the what is it called register view
and paste that one from before here okay
so what all we did here is we made sure
that the register view
it is indeed the register view and the
login view is empty at the moment so
what you'll need to do you see there's
an error here that says that okay you
have a stateful widget for login but it
doesn't have any build function
so you'll now need to create that build
function and of course you could do it
by hand
but
it's i mean
it's not really
it's not really that
good of an idea to
write all that code by hand of course in
the beginning you may say that oh well i
just want to learn the best way to learn
is to type and i completely understand
that but there are some things like
there are limits i also believe like
once you've done it once or twice you'll
kind of get bored of doing that or
you'll get tired of doing that so i
actually suggest that for these
functions that you're overriding the
best way is actually get your editor
text editor or ide to complete these
things for you so i'm going to go on
this error and just say command dot on
mac and control dot on linux and windows
and say create one missing override okay
and in here we just say return
okay
so that's our login view and you can see
here
now we have
a register view
that is right here and then we also have
a login view all right
so
let's go then
in our main dart file here i can see
that there is a register and let's just
actually restart this
hot restart okay so we have a register
and
our login view is completely empty so
now um
what we need to do basically is kind of
like um
it's kind of work on our login view
because this is this is like the goal of
this chapter
we need to have a login view and up
until this point what we've been doing
is kind of like create a register view
with all the code in it a separate login
view
which was our previously
previously created registry so
i mean this is all a lot of talk just to
say that we have a registered view
but we don't have a login view and we
need to work on login views so
if you remember um
wow i mean you don't actually have to
remember you can look at it here the
register view has two fields enter your
email here and for your password here
and
this is this their register v and login
are very similar to each other what
register view does differently is that
it creates this it basically does a call
to firebase that says
create user with email and password
but if you think about it everything
else is very similar
sorry about that
so you need to create you need to make
sure in both of them that firebase is
initialized
you will have two text fields email
password and you will have a button one
for register and for one for login
so
what we could do to be honest with you
is to now go and copy this code that we
got from our login view
okay that happens i actually forgot that
so let's go and copy this code again
from here
literally get grab everything from there
and put it in our login view like that
and change this register button to log
in
so now we have two copies of the same
view basically once it's registered the
other one says log in all right
so
and what we could do is now go to our
main dart file here
and instead of returning the register
view we could just return the login view
because we want to work on the login
view now okay we have a user registered
and now we need to work on login and as
a side note
if you follow the previous chapter
you'll you'll know that we actually did
register a a valid user with firebase
and
what you could do is to go to your
firebase console
as we could do now just an ad hoc i
hadn't planned for this
but what we could do say
console.firebasegoggle.com
ensure that you're logged in with your
account
then i'm going to go to this uh project
that we created mynotes flutter project
go in there and then go into
authentication and you can actually then
see the user that you created
using the flutter application that
you're actually working on so when you
call this function in your in your
register view this function
firebase os instance create user with
email and password that user was indeed
created in the firebase console so here
you have a user you could also disable
this user and do other things but we're
just going to leave it like that for now
okay
so what you need to do now is instead of
register view tell your home page to
render the login view and you could just
type login view
and if you just
type a login view like that you will get
an error of course because login view
isn't in scope but i believe visual
studio code could actually help with
that because you see we haven't imported
login view at all so
this main dart file doesn't know what
login view is
exactly the same thing happened here do
you remember if we didn't have these
imports we got lots of errors saying
that they i don't know where this class
is so the same thing is happening in
this main dart file all right so i
believe in visual studio code now i'm
kind of improvising but i think if you
set login view and just press enter boom
it does an import automatically for you
and let's see where it is here you see
but if you're not comfortable doing that
just type login view
by hand and do the same thing i showed
you before just command dot on mac or
controlled up in windows and linux and
say import okay so it's going to import
it for you
now we have the login view and if i
press command s or actually we have to
do a hot restart
you see now there is a login button
right here okay
so what we'll need to do is as you can
see in the caption now that we're
working on logging the login view go to
your login view
and go here where the button is pressed
you see text button unpressed
what we'll need to do here is to
call the a new function on our firebase
auth instance instead of create user
with email and password we're going to
say firebase auth
got instance
but sign in with email and password and
you can see the function signature is
very similar to create user with email
and password in that it takes two
parameters namely email and password
both of type string and then what it
does return in fact is user credential
and do you remember create user with
email and password also return user
credentials so
it's very simple to switch between login
and register in that in that sense so
grab the sign in with email and password
name
that's the only thing we're interested
in and just paste it here instead of
create user okay
just gonna save that
some reason my
scrcpy crashed and i have no idea why
so
that's okay that wasn't planned what we
could do is to go to our and i can see
you see it got an aborted so what we
could do is to go to our terminal and
i'm gonna say scr cpy okay
and i'm going to bring it to the screen
here so
and also if you're if you noticed here
we have a login button but the title
here still says register so let's go and
fix that let's go into the app bar and
just say login
all right
and actually problem is i can also see
that my
as scrcpy crash also the running of this
process this application on that android
phone also crashed so there is i mean
the flutter instance of this project
isn't really running at the moment so
what i'll have to do is to go to main
dart and say run without debugging so
and it's now launching doing a gradle
build gradle remember from the previous
chapters is for android
and if it's using xcode it is for ios
all right so
it's doing the greater build so if
everything goes according to the plan
then we should get a login
title up there and while this is doing
its work i'm going to go to my notes and
just ensure
that i've talked about the things that i
promise i'm going to talk
about all right it's installing our
application i'm gonna remove the widget
inspector and now you can see we have a
login
on top and
that is working as expected all right so
as you can see here after the logging
call here sign in with email and
password we're doing a print
now
what we could do here is to
enter some information of a user that
doesn't exist okay so i'm just going to
say my personal email
and i'm going to say foo bar path
and i'm then going to bring up the
console here as you'll see the debug
console clear it
um
and i'm going to actually remove
or do something like this so you can see
the debug console a little bit better in
its entirety and i'm going to press the
login button all right
and then
sorry about that
so we have now um
the next thing that we need to handle as
you can see
uh
i'll perhaps increase the size even more
here so you'll see it better
when i press the login button
excuse me
using a user
that doesn't exist meaning that we
haven't registered that user then we got
an error here that says firebase off
user not found and that that makes sense
actually completely because
the
we haven't actually done any
registration for this user okay
so
what we could hear what we could do here
is to go in
here and i'm gonna bring things back up
kind of the way they were
here
all right so
here we're recalling this function uh
let me decrease the size because it's
absolutely ginormous
in here
signing with email and password
um
we need to handle
a thing called an exception and i don't
think we talked about exceptions to be
honest with you while i was i was
teaching you about dart if you know
about exceptions you could just skip
through kind of skim through this little
bit of the video but if you're if you're
not a software development developer
from before or software engineer then
you may not know what an exception is an
exception is when
things go wrong and you haven't kind of
thought about those things from the
beginning so as you can as you
for instance if you're if you're working
with
if you're a software if you're a
designer or a product owner
haven't done software development before
you may have also used other pieces of
software and sometimes software crashes
just like scr cpy just crashed a few
minutes ago that is perhaps
probably
an exception or an error that the
software developers who created scrcpy
hadn't counted with so they hadn't
counted with
that
an error might occur in this scenario
for instance so
not having handled that the application
crashes it means that an exception
happens and error happens that the
developers of that program hadn't
accounted for so
and this is an exception that you're
seeing here in your flutter application
so firebase is saying that you're trying
to log in with a user that doesn't exist
so what do you want to do with it i
can't continue after this i don't know
what to do so
the way to handle exceptions in
flutter or in dart actually is using a
try catch block so i'm going to bring it
here put the entire code for your user
credential creation in the try statement
as you can see here and then go in here
and say catch b
in parenthesis for now
all right just like that
and then i'm just gonna say something
that happened
in single codes
all right so you can see here now we
have a try block as indicated here with
this line it's all the way from on top
to here and then we have a catch block
the way try catch works is that it as
its name indicates it tries to do the
work that you're saying it needs to be
done in the trial block should anything
bad happen it will go to various catch
statements that you can't then place
after that try okay
so
as you saw in the logs this error
let's see if we can find it here
it was of type firebase auth uh let me
see on handle exception but we didn't
actually get its type unfortunately so
what we could do here is
print something bad happen and then
print the error itself okay
so i'm just going to say clear the logs
command s
and then i'm going to press the login
again
sorry here and you can see now it says
something bad happened firebase auth
user not found and then some information
and
we could actually say print e
run time type and doing that will
actually give you information about
which class of exception this is because
you see
as you're working with flutter and as
you're working with software generally
you're creating software you're writing
code different types of exceptions
happen and these exceptions have their
own identity every exception has its own
identity it's the series of classes or
different places that it may come from
in dart you can pretty much
anything can become an error even a text
can become an error or enum can become
an error so
when you come to this catch block as
i'll move my mouse over it you can see
that here it says i don't even know what
this is this is an object so
it could be anything
but you are actually in the in your
cache block you're mostly interested in
exceptions that might occur from
firebase so
since we don't really know what this
type is we're gonna
print it out to the console
and we're gonna have a look at what type
it is so let me do
a little bit of them
how should i do this
is this a little bit better arrangement
perhaps so you can see what happens yeah
perhaps then what i'm going to do
command this hot reload
and go here press the login button and
you'll see that the type of that
exception is firebase auth exception all
right
so what we need to do now is to go to
our code
and
handle
firebase auth exceptions not just any
exception as we're doing here
because we're catching any exception so
what we want to do is to catch firebase
off exceptions in our cache block all
right and a way to do that is i'm going
to do this now
and i'm going to do like we were doing
before get rid of the consoles to see
more of the code
so what you could do you can have
specialized cache blocks in dart and
that means that you are not catching
everything but you tell dark that look
in this particular catch block i'm
interested only in exceptions of this
type and
as you might have guessed that already a
try block can be accompanied by more
than one catch block
this cache block that you can see here
is called catch all it catches every
exception that might occur in the
running of the code inside the try block
however
if you're interested in specific
exceptions in this case firebase auth
exception i believe oh i've cleared it
but i think it was firebase off
exception i'm going to run it again
go to the login button and you can see
it says firebase off exception so we're
interested specifically in that so let's
go and say tell dart that we're
interested in that i'm just i'm going to
say on
firebase off exception
catch
e
all right
so this is the format of catching
specific exceptions you prefix your
catch statement with the keyword on and
then you write the type the runtime type
or the class name of the type of
exception that you're interested in
handling all right
so in this case we said on firebase off
the exception catchy and we're gonna
remove this catch from there
and we're gonna go here
actually i don't even have to cut and
what you'll need to do in here just say
print e code
you see
save this before i before i tell you
what i was going to say after uc
let's test this let's say login and
you'll see that the code is used or not
found
so
now that we told dark that we're
specializing in catching exceptions of
firebase auth exception then this e is
not an object anymore really let's see
if we can get some help now it says okay
if i can catch exceptions of firebase
auth exception then i know that the
error that i can pass to you is of that
type
now that you catching firebase
authexception you can go to this code
and you see there are different
properties that you can read from
message code email credential et cetera
et cetera okay
so we're now interested in the code
so
as the caption right here shows at the
bottom of the screen you'll see that we
need to handle e-code equal to user not
found all right so let's say if e code
is equal to user not found
then let's say print
user not found like that else e code oh
sorry actually we're not going to do it
outside kind of like running ahead of
myself a little bit there
so
we have now um
e-code user not found then we're just
saying print user not found okay i'm
going to clear the logs here go back to
see our cpy here and i'm just gonna say
login and you'll see all it does it says
user not found all right
so
so that's that we haven't really i mean
the caption at the bottom left of the
screen says handle but depending on your
um background you may
expect handle to do different things for
a software for a seasoned software
engineer handle may actually mean that
well do something about it okay tell him
tell the user like oh i couldn't log in
the user couldn't be found or
whatever reason just show something to
the user and we could do that but at the
moment we don't have the capacity to do
that we don't really know how to handle
that so
what we need to do then is to simply say
print so we just print it to the screen
so this is our handling for now okay
it's very simple all it does is just
ensures that no exception is thrown to
the user's face or that the application
doesn't crash
okay that was a lot of information um
now as the caption here shows in the
login view we also need to handle wrong
password
and i mean as you can see here the e
code is a string so anything here could
happen that could be defined by string
and one other
excuse me
one of those errors actually is wrong
password so let's test that
in here let's say else if if the code is
not user not found just print
something else happened
and then print
the errors code to the screen okay
so i'm going to save this
and i'm going to then go here and then
actually change this email to an
existing email which was the one that i
registered
and password i believe was foobar or
something
clickfu bar maybe
and i'm going to say login and you can
see here it says now something else
happened wrong password so
that could that could kind of mean that
well yeah actually that isn't my
password this foo bar was in my password
i don't even remember what it was maybe
it was full bar bass
but that is great it says something else
happen an e code and that's exactly what
we have to
sorry about that
and that is exactly what we need to
handle here um wrong password so in your
else statement say else if
e code
is
wrong password
then we're going to say print
okay
man is
so that's there clear the logs i'm going
to say log in and you'll see the message
wrong password
printed to the screen
all right
a lot of work
we've done quite a lot of work now in
the login view but we haven't really put
much energy into the register view you
see they're very similar in that they do
almost the same api calls with the email
and password ones that sign in the other
ones that's register
however in if if we go to our main dart
file you'll see in here in our register
view we're just calling the api and kind
of like hoping for the best there's no
try catch statement here okay so what we
could do is have a look at how we did it
for login we put the api call inside the
try block you see what we need to do is
to go to main dart and for our register
view
here register view state do the same
thing let's put this in a try block here
okay
and then just say catch or say on
firebase off exception
this is i mean i'm not going to explain
this again because it's exactly what we
did just in the login view
i believe firebase authexception didn't
really exist in this in this dart file
before but that is what visual studio
code helped me with as i typed it and
pressed enter for auto completion
then it must have been imported
somewhere
or it was probably part of firebase auth
dart i believe actually so if i command
click on it
it goes to firebase auth so that's why i
it probably didn't have to import
anything because it was already imported
as a part of firebase auth okay
oh wow that was a lot of information
also
now that we're working on the register
view let's go to our main
dar main function here and since we're
only seeing the login view let's switch
this back to register view
and command s but this is not going to
change anything as you remember hot
reload doesn't have an effect of any
changes that you it doesn't have an
effect on anything that you're changing
the main function remember that you have
to hot restart okay
so hot restart now we're in the register
view
and we need to now handle wrong password
uh actually
no that's not the login sorry about that
now we need to handle
this weak password
so
as you're working with uh firebase zoom
you will notice that it has its own set
of security rules you also can override
these security rules later for your
server if you want to for instance you
can expect or you can say all my users
have to have passwords that are 18 um
characters long and a mixture of digits
and alpha numerical values etcetera
etcetera but
there are some default security rules
set up on firebase
for credentials that every user needs to
abide by so let's actually have a look
at that and
let's
do a print here and i'm going to say
print e
code okay
and as you'll see in the caption as you
are seeing in the caption there is an e
code of equal to weak password that
needs to be handled so i'm going to go
here try to register user with my
personal email and the password of a b
c all right then i'm going to bring up
the console clear the console a little
bit
i'm going to do this so you'll see it a
little bit better
then i'm gonna try to register with a
password of abc press register
what happened
here you see the code was weak password
and as you'll expect yeah weak password
that is too weak a password to even be
used anywhere so
um
so what we need to do here is to handle
the weak password
error basically i'm gonna take in my
notes that i've talked about some other
topics of login
all right so we'll handle weak password
the way we handle the other
errors in login view
then say if e code
is equal to
weak password
and let's just say print week password
okay
and we'll say
um so that's that's that for now okay
and i'm going to just bring up the um
debug console again
and press the register button one more
time
now you'll see the information let me
bring it so you can actually see it
yeah you can actually see it great you
can see weak password being printed here
all right so that was great
now let's go let me bring the let make
the screen a little bit bigger
the next thing we have to handle
is um in this register view as you can
see in the caption here
you can also get an error called email
already in use so if you go to the else
statement here again and print
e
if i try to register with the same email
that i registered before
this user already exists and if even if
i have quite a good password for this
user so i'm going to say fubar bass
1029.
so we know that the error is not going
to be the password like it's actually a
good password well
better than fubar baz at least and that
or abc so i'm just going to say register
and
do we not get any value here or did i
even press the register button
is it really
registering pixelity a b
no i don't think so
um
oh i hadn't saved the file oops so yeah
i haven't saved my changes i'm gonna say
register
oh now it says email already in use and
that is exactly i mean that is pretty
much what we have to handle right
because we're printing e so
um i didn't have to say oh no surprises
there
so let's handle email already and use so
i'm going to copy this email already and
use string just exactly as it's
mentioned here
and i'm going to go to else and say
else if e code is equal to
that string and then say uh email is
already
in use okay
and then save it there
clear the logs press the register button
again you can see now it says email is
already in use okay
so
um
let me also have a little bit of a look
at my notes
um
i can also i mean to be honest with you
in the notes i don't see anywhere
that we're really trying to handle
uh these errors like actually doing
something about them all right
so
perhaps a better thing
to do would be
to really like show a message or
something to the user
and i'm kind of wondering that right now
like whether that's a good idea or a bad
idea for this chapter and perhaps just
doing a print will suffice to be honest
with you
not entirely sure about that so
um let's leave it at that for now okay
i'm also gonna go here and make sure
that i'm not yeah i'm in do not disturb
so let's leave it leave it at that email
already use perfect okay let's leave it
at that
now the next thing that we have to
handle
it could also write a situation where
the user tries to enter an invalid email
all right so let's put an else statement
here and say print
um e code again
save it
let's go and remove this add sign so it
becomes an invalid email and try to
press the register button okay now you
can see uh you can't actually see now
you can see at the bottom in the logs it
says invalid email and that is the code
for that error so let's handle invalid
email now all right
so i'm going to go here and say else if
e code we call to invalid email then
we're going to say print invalid email
entered all right and save it
so clear the logs
tap the register button and now you'll
see invalid email entered okay
so
i mean that's really
um all we have to do
right now for our
error handling and as we're going on i
mean to be honest with you i still have
a little bit of time to figure out
whether we're really going to handle
these things by and by that i mean like
if we are
if we need to display some some error to
the user okay and we may need to do that
but it is a little bit complicated like
depending on how we want to handle it do
we want to show like a message to the
user do you want to show a toast to the
user um
or do we want to like display another
screen to the user and that's kind of
like unclear even to me right now so
maybe we'll iron these things out then
as we go on
in in the upcoming chapters as well
so
now i can see here
that login
we've talked about that
and what we need to do then
in order to be able to
carry on with the upcoming chapters
is actually to make sure that we are
logged in to the application you see
we've worked on the register view we've
worked on the login view
we're trying like so many different
combinations here to register new user
login so i personally don't know at the
moment whether
this application firebase instance
actually has a logged in user and if
you're familiar with like python django
or flask or if you're doing nodejs or
whatever development like backend
development
you can be a logged in user but still
end up being in a login view
so if you send a login login user to a
login view doesn't mean that the user
isn't logged in
instead it means well that user is
logged in but may want to log in as a
different user so that is the case in
our application as well we have a
register screen a login view but i
personally don't know what the state of
the application at the moment is are we
logged in or are we not logged in
because we're kind of like playing with
different views here okay so that's very
important now because in the
next chapter i can see in chapter 14 we
are going to work with
um
we're working on separating the app
initialization from the login and
register screens because you can see at
the moment we have this future builder
that is
initializing firebase and it is doing
lots of work comes with snapshots stay
done blah blah and we're doing the exact
same thing in two views login view and
the register view so
what we need to do is kind of like
separate that logic
and ensure that we display the correct
view depending on yeah what the state of
the application is and before we can
then continue or start that chapter we
kind of need to make sure that the user
the current user is logged in all right
so let's go to our um
main dart here and login logged in views
already displayed so i don't really you
don't need to worry about this part
import login view
what you need to do now is to make sure
that instead of register view we're
displaying the login view
and remember now we're saving something
changing something in the main
function so hot reload isn't going to
work so you need to do hot restart
so we'll get to that login view
and let's then enter valid details here
so i'm going to say pixelityab.gmail.com
and i think the password was fubar best
to be honest
i'm going to press the login button
all right and there we got the
credentials for this user
wow that was a lot of information and i
understand that um
so what we need to work on now i'm going
to take some stuff in my notes
is
as i mentioned we need to for the next
chapter i mean we're kind of done with
this chapter to be honest we've talked a
lot about like exception handling
separated the login view from the
register view but our register view is
still in the main dart we're gonna we're
gonna
fix that soon
but what you need to know to do before
you continue with the next chapter and
just ensure that you're displaying the
login view to the user and that you're
actually logging logging in with a valid
username and password this ensures that
the firebase instance that is running in
this application right now is going to
cache that information locally on ios is
going to cache that information in a
secure storage called keychain and on
android i think it's called shared
preferences or something like that
so that information is going to be
securely stored now on that telephone
which for me is an android telephone
right here and
when i restart the application whenever
if i like shut down my
telephone restart the telephone the os
come back up that information is already
saved on that telephone so my user is
logged in all right
so just ensure that before you continue
with the next chapter that you've
registered the user first and that
you've logged in with that user from
your application so that information is
cached inside the application all right
good a lot of information
in the next chapter
we're going to separate the app
initialization from the login and the
register screens there are only a few
steps that we have to do
in that chapter
so
so i don't think that chapter is going
to actually be so long
so grab a cup of tea coffee whatever you
want chocolate or whatever it is and
i will see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter number 14
of our flutter course
as you saw in the previous chapter we
worked on the login view now we have a
login view and a register view in place
and what you also saw is that we did
some very simple
error handling for various scenarios
such as
uh email address already registered
weak password um
invalid email
incorrect password or wrong password i
think it was called so
now we have two views in place
um we have but we have two main issues
to address here
the
registration or the register view that
we created still lives
in our
main.dart file
and the other issue is as the caption
here displays is that the widgets are
doing app initialization
if you remember from the code
there was this firebase initialization
api
invocation that we had to do and since
the login view and the register view are
very similar to each other they're both
doing the
initialization of firebase
what we're going to do in this chapter
is
separate these um
initializations and
make them one that's that's the first
first thing we need to do so we just
have one initialization that's going to
happen
and what we're also going to do is to
bring the register view in its own file
so this this chapter is going to be a
quick one unlike the other chapters and
i think that's kind of refreshing to be
honest with you otherwise all chapters
are going to be very long and
very detailed
so
with that said let's then um
let's then
start with the first thing we have to do
which is
basically to move the register view into
views register view okay
i'm going to see if i can bring up
visual studio code um
how we had left it before
and i'm going to bring up scrcpy
which
is my android phone running our flutter
application right now
so let's do as the caption says here i'm
going to make the screen a little bit
bigger so you can see better
then go to your project uh or explorer
here visual studio core if you're using
android studio you can go go to the
navigator there as well there's a
similar one in android studio or if
you're using sublime that is exactly the
same thing here on the left hand side
you can see the project structure
then go to lib and then views as we have
the login view there let's create a view
called register view so right click here
and say new file and i'm going to say
register mu dot dart
okay so then we have to as the question
says go back to our main dart file and
grab this register view from here
group all the register view including
its register view state
grab all of that
cut it in mac you do it with command x
and in windows and linux i think you do
control x so
um i cut that and i'm gonna then bring
it into register view here
as you saw in the previous chapter doing
these things usually cause a lot of
headache
for
for your editor because i mean it's not
a headache for you because we can easily
fix it for us it's not a problem but
it's just the editor that doesn't
understand where all these classes are
located at so i i've explained this
previously in
the exact previous chapter before this
so i'm not going to explain it again so
let's say command dot in visual studio
code and then say import material to fix
all the stateful widget problems and all
the things that all the classes are
stored in material dart here in the
flotter package okay
then we have other problems such as
firebase so
command dot import firebase core to fix
that command dot import firebase options
here
it's that problem and we will also have
to import firebase off i believe and
that is also fixed all right so now we
have a register view here perfect
and um
if you see here in our main dart now
there are lots of things that are
imported which aren't which aren't
needed anymore
so let's remove those you can see these
things are actually
you may say okay well how do i find all
these problems like there's lots of
issues here but had i not come back to
the main dart file i wouldn't have seen
them and the way to fix that is to
actually bring up your
problems view here and you'll see that
there are lots of problems stated that
you can go go and fix those you see
print statements are here and then
unused imports which you can which you
can clean up as well so
that's how you can use the problems
window
i'm going to do that by hand now remove
this and remove this so we have a clean
void main function here all right i'm
gonna do a hot restart just to make sure
everything's working as expected
then we have the login view here okay
so the next thing we need to do now is
as the notes i'm actually going to go to
my notes and make sure that i have
talked about the previous point
so the next thing we need to do is to
create a dedicated home page that does
the app initialization and depending on
whether the user is logged in or logged
out or if the user is verified or not
then it's going to display the correct
widget on the screen okay so
just to explain that a little bit more
is that i mean you i can say that
you see in your main function here that
when your application run you it runs
you're telling it to go to login view
but why
why are we saying go to login view
why are we saying go to register view we
have no logic at the moment that says
are you logged in then show the login
view or if you're not like me and show
the registry so
that's what we're going to do with our
home page okay so imagine the home page
kind of being the manager of the
different routes that your application
can manage so saying that oh if this
condition then do this if that condition
display the other screen so
we need a home page and conveniently
named is home page i mean lots of other
people may try to call it something else
like a route page or whatever
but for now we're going to go with
homepage because it's just so easy to
understand for everyone so
let's then go in here
and say we want to have
a stateless widget stl and we're going
to call it home page okay and i'm gonna
press escape after that so now we have a
stateless widget called home page in our
main dart file
now
what we need to do then after doing that
we need to go in our main dart file and
instead of saying login view let's just
say home page okay and if i press
command is remember this is not going to
take any effect immediately because hot
reload doesn't take into consideration
it changes the main function here so you
have to do a hot restart so you'll see
black screen right now okay
so
that's that
what we need to do now is
to
basically have some scaffold in our
homepage because we don't want to
display just an empty screen to the user
okay
so
let's go in here for our container
instead say we return a scaffold
talked about scaffold in previous
chapters so i'm not going to explain
that again
and let's go and create an app bar with
which we've also talked about
title accounts text and say home page
okay
well command s in mac or control s in
linux and windows to save this file and
you'll see the changes
took effect immediately
all right so
what do we need in the home page we said
that the home page needs to initialize
firebase it needs to first do that so
that we can get rid of this code in both
register view you see this code future
builder firebase initialize app and then
connection state done blah blah and also
we have the exact same code in our login
view so
there's a lot of code to write in every
view that we're gonna develop though
this application isn't gonna have so
many views maybe six seven views but
still we don't wanna do initialize app
in every view and do a future builder
it's just a lot of code so that's what
our
homepage is gonna do okay
so let's do that uh let's go and grab
this code um
excuse me
let's grab this code with the future
builder pretty much maybe the entire
build function okay from our login view
so go to your login view grab the entire
build function until its end which is
here this parenthesis okay ending
parenthesis
close your login view close your
register view if you want to then go and
replace the entire override of widget
build in your home page
with that code that you just cut or
sorry copied from the login view paste
it right here
now we we don't want the home page to
have any logic that has anything to do
with
um
text fields this homepage is we're going
to use it for something a lot more noble
so you don't need all the text fields
and
all of these columns and uh your text
button so
go to here where you're creating the
column in connection state done
and grab that code all the way from
return so if i fold it you'll see that
that is the entire return and i'm going
to actually delete it
oops it didn't delete the entire code
okay so i'm going to do it by hand from
the return
all the way down here
to where the
column ends
okay
and instead of that column what we're
gonna do
is just return a text
that says
okay
just like that so if firebase
initialization is done it's just gonna
say done and let's also change the text
here and just call it home all right
now that we've done that you can see we
still have some problems with firebase
not being imported because i deleted
those um
um
imports previously so i'm gonna fix that
now command dot on firebase and say
import that and command dot on default
firebase options or control dot
depending on whether on your linux
whether if you're on linux or a mac or
windows import firebase options
all right so now you'll see we have a
homepage that just displays the word
done here
once the connection state of our future
which is initialized app of firebase is
actually done so hot reload
and you'll see hotdog sorry
done is also displayed hot done
um
so uh
i'm gonna take that in my notes that
i've talked about that
all right
the next thing we need to do in this
chapter is um
to make sure that the user is not null
and that also the user is verified so
under some rare circumstances with
firebase such as when you haven't
initialized your firebase application
using initialize app the user that is
stored in the firebase um
firebase
code or in the instance of firebits
running inside your application may
actually be null and we've talked about
null in uh previous chapters where we
talked about dart and it's basics so you
can go back to those chapters and watch
those so i'm not going to explain what
null is again
but just quickly null is simply said the
absence of a value in this case absence
of the user so
what we need to do in our application is
to ensure
that
a
the user the current user in the
application is
um non-null meaning that it should be
present and also that the user's email
should be verified okay
so
you may be asking why
is it important for a user's email to be
verified
the reason
i mean also before i say why is it
important for a user's email to be
verified maybe let's talk first about
what an email verification is and
that whether you've already seen it or
not so in a lot of services online if
for instance you go to a website
even if it's a shopping website or
amazon or whatever ebay if you say okay
i want to register a new user and you
say okay here's my email address here's
a password of my choosing um
once you do that
you will be logged into the website
they'll say okay if this email doesn't
exist already
i'm gonna allow you to register this but
then you wouldn't really be able to do
so much with the website you can search
stuff but you probably won't be able to
buy things
unless until unless you've
verified your email and that means that
as soon as you register for amazon for
instance then it will send you an email
to the email that that you chose upon
registration and there will usually be a
link in that email and say thank you for
registering a user at amazon or ebay
click on this link to verify your email
address
you've probably seen emails like that so
you could just go to your inbox and
search for verify and you'll probably
find lots of emails that ask you verify
your account with the service so um
now let's now that we talked about what
email verification is let's talk about
why it's important well let's say that
i'm a user and i want to use this
application that we're developing so i
want to score some notes in it
then i'll go and and register myself
under an email that i don't own
all right so let's say then i register
my
your email address with a password of my
choosing since you haven't registered
your email address yet with the service
icon and ahead of you and register your
email address with the service and now
i'll just log in
remember i'm not logging into your email
i'm logging into this application with
your email now
now i've taken that email so if you then
who's the rightful owner of your email
address comes to this application and
say oh i'm a foobarbaz gmail.com and i
want to register an account with this
application and it says oops that email
address was already taken so you'd be
like how is that taken that's my email
address so
that is the importance of email
verification what we need to do in our
application is to make sure that
whenever someone comes and registers a
user using the email address and a
password of their choosing then we're
gonna send a real email using firebase
to that email address and say
hey you just registered a user here make
sure that you click on this link that
says verify blah blah to actually verify
your user with our application or with
our file with our applications firebase
instance that sits on firebase cloud all
right so
so what we need to do now is to go in
here in the connection state done you
see
let's then check the current user okay
let's see if this current user actually
is logged into the application so let's
say firebase
um
and then let's say
firebase app i believe it's called
instance
let's see got instance
changelog firebase
all right let's see if we can actually
google that together okay so this is
good for you to also see
right base flutter get current user
we're probably going to end up on some
sort of a stack overflow
and we'll have a look at how we can
actually retrieve the current user as
you can see the response here is from a
user
whose username is quite
dissu kurt jr i apologize if i'm
butching this name but you can see that
it's provided here for you that it says
firebaseos.instance
and using that instance then you can get
the current user so let's do the same
thing here let's say firebase off
dot instance
and then
current user okay
i'm gonna get rid of this screen on the
left which which is our project browser
and i'm gonna print this statement right
here before we return the done text okay
so i'll bring up the debug console clear
the debug console and i'm going to say
command s all right
and since we've made a lot of changes
here you see we created a home page lots
of stuff in here so what we need to do
is just do a hot restart basically
flutter in this case wasn't able to
really understand
what we've changed in our home page so
there were so many changes that it just
couldn't handle so a hot restart is the
remedy there
now you can see here as we printed the
current user
i'm going to do this so you can see more
of the
the output i'm going to bring it up a
little bit i'm going to increase the
size quite dramatically so you can see
it better as well
and
i'm going to highlight the parts that
were actually printed so this is what
firebase or this is what the print
statement printed out for us and this is
user credentials that were created by
firebase and
if you remember from the previous
chapter i said that make sure before you
come to this chapter that you have a
login user and this is the reason i
wanted us to i wanted the firebase
instance in our application to already
know that you're logged in so that when
we print your current user credentials
then as you can see it says here's the
email address
and then there's a property called email
verified false and it says are you an
anonymous user
false and if you remember from one of
the earlier chapters when i talked about
the firebase setup then
an anonymous user is a user who hasn't
really logged into the application yet
and
firebase is intelligent enough to
understand that any user who comes to
your application who hasn't logged in
before or and their login
information isn't saved in keychain or
shared preferences on android then that
user is anonymous anonymous by default
so if you didn't take the
um last action from the previous chapter
and you didn't log into the application
with your current user
then you will actually be anonymous here
so this flag will say true
but since we've already done that we've
logged into the application then you'll
see our credentials being printed to the
screen
now this is the part that i was
interested in which is email verified
and it says false
so what we're going to do here is to say
take the user so we're saying a final
user is firebase off instance current
user i'm going to decrease the size a
little bit here okay
and i'm gonna make the screen a little
bit bigger so you can see it better
and let's go then create an if statement
here
and let's say that we're gonna say what
what have i planned for it let's just
say if user is
verified email verified then we're going
to say print
you are a verified user
and otherwise
we're going to say print you need
verify your email first
so
you see here because i'm so glad that
actually we're seeing this error you can
see the entire error
it says
how can i scroll here it says the
property email verify can't be
unconditionally accessed because the
receiver can be null try making the
access condition using question mark dot
or adding a null check to the target so
what this is saying is if you go to this
user move your mouse over it uh if i can
do that oh no
here you'll see that it says user is an
optional user so what firebase has done
here is saying
this current user property that you can
see here is an optional user meaning
that well if something goes wrong and
firebase can't actually calculate your
current user
for instance if you disable anonymous
users which you can actually do
then firebase will be said it will be
saying oops
null user
the user is absent i don't know who this
user is so
that is firebase api telling your
application that if you're using my api
then you need to handle this case you
can't just ask me if the email is
verified because the user may actually
be null the user may be absent so
there was a great suggestion here you
saw here that says you can conditionally
access that property using the question
mark dot
syntax so let's do that question mark
done but as you do that you see you'll
get another problem
it says okay
you're asking me to compare an optional
boolean
with
an actual boolean because remember your
if conditions need to resolve in into a
true or false so
um so in this case what you can do is
to either create something called for
instance if an intermediate variable you
can say final
email verified
and you'll say that is equal to user
optional access to email verified field
or false you see this is the question
mark question mark which we've already
talked about when we talked about dark
basics so
what you said here is take the left hand
side of this operator of question mark
question mark which is a null aware
operator you say if the left hand side
exists take it otherwise take the value
on the right okay so now if you move
your mouse over email verify you'll see
that it's a boolean all right
perfect so you could either do that or
get rid of this intermediate variable
that you created here and literally just
put the exact same code in your if
statement and that will work exactly as
it did up there so let's just go ahead
with that one less line of code
one
line of code less maybe
um all right so
if the user's email verified or false is
true
which means that if the user's email
verification could be read as true or
false and if you can't use false if the
equation then in itself is true then the
user is verified
otherwise the user isn't verified so
let's do command s there
let's bring up our console i'm going to
change the screen layout a little bit so
you can see better
and you can see here it says you need to
verify your email i actually clean the
screen a little bit and command s again
so you'll see a little bit less
information on screen and you can see
our print statement which was here got
printed saying that yeah you haven't
verified your email and you need to do
that first
okay a lot of information but maybe less
than the other chapters and to be honest
with you this is all we have to talk
about in this chapter i just wanted to
display
or and show you that um or actually
explain first what email verification is
why is it important and that we're we
are going to use email verification in
our in our application as you'll soon
see
and how can you actually read that
property from a firebase user
great
that was all for this chapter now the
next chapter is going to be a little bit
different you may actually expect a
continuation of this chapter you would
think that we're going to jump right
into email verification but i have
intentionally actually put a little bit
of a pause in our
flow because this is something you'll
have to do as a software developer
sometimes in that if you see something
not
kind of correct something isn't working
right then you'll need to address it as
soon as possible and this is something
we're going to address in the next
chapter the problem here that you may
may if you're a seasoned software
developer or may not have thought about
is that
we are just writing code on our computer
this code could be easily deleted by a
malicious program a virus or if
something happens to our computer all
this could just go away and you'll lose
everything that you've written so if
you're not coming from a software
engineering background then you may not
know what git and github are
now
i'm not going to scare you to be honest
with you this is not something scary but
um
what we need to do is just to make sure
that we have a backup of our code and
just that's just common sense like even
if you're a designer even if you're a
music producer even if you're a soft if
if your product owner whoever
or product manager you probably know
that whatever you're working on needs to
be saved somewhere safely so if you have
a video file you're not just going to
put it on your computer you're probably
going to make a backup of it if you're
working with figma that that file is
already shared in the cloud is sorry not
shared it's already stored in the cloud
so
it's very rarely that you will work on
pieces of um documents that are not
securely stored in some sort of cloud
and even if you're working for instance
with a document then nowadays there's
also shared like um sorry there are
cloud
solutions for storing your documents
securely in the cloud so
um i mean it pretty much
almost always when you're working on a
user generated document or a source code
in this case you'll need to make sure
that it's securely stored in the cloud
and that's what we're going to do in the
next chapter so we're going to talk
about git and github we're going to set
up our gpg keys
or pgp keys how do you want to say it
and we're actually going to dive a
little bit deep into git and what it
actually means and why it is why is it
good why do software developers talk a
lot about git and as you might know
this course well
not might you already know this course
is about flutter
but i couldn't help put this chapter in
because i believe if you're not a
software developer if you're coming from
another background
then it is my duty kind of to tell you
about git and github and why is it
important how to use it how i like to do
very simple tasks with getting github so
um
so let's then prepare ourselves for the
next chapter which is going to be a
little bit less coding it's not really
we're not at all almost not at all going
to be working on the source code we're
mainly going to work with git and github
so
with that said i will wrap up this
chapter and i'll see you in the next one
hello and welcome to chapter 15 of this
letter course
in previous chapters we talked a lot
about setting up our project so we've so
far been working a lot with setting up
the project and the basics we also
created our login and registered views
in our flutter application as i was
developing this course myself i got to
the point that there was a lot of code
being written by me and then i needed to
make sure that it is stored
in a in a place where i can always go
back to even if i lose this information
on my computer that i can go back to
that place and then retrieve that code
so um
if you're a software developer if you're
if you're a seasoned software developer
from before and you know what git and
github are and you're comfortable using
them and you know how to set up for
instance your secure keys with gpg
then you can safely jump over this
chapter but if you're a designer product
owner product manager whoever who
doesn't know what git and github are or
maybe need some help setting those
things up
then this is a good chapter for you
uh otherwise you can just skim quickly
over
so
let's
let's talk quickly about what git and
github are and why we need them um as i
mentioned when you're working with your
code for instance as i was while
developing this course then you're
writing a lot of code which
is i mean intrinsically valuable because
your time was translated into those
pieces of code as you were writing the
code you spent some time and energy and
effort and wrote the code so it is quite
an important piece of information for
you just to lose and depending on the
type of project you're working on for
instance this project it has taken me
quite a lot of time to even develop the
idea of the project and put it together
so while i was while i was putting
together the idea of the course and
written writing all the bits and pieces
that i have to explain in every video i
made quite a lot of backups of that of
those ideas because had i not done that
and had i just put everything in just
one piece of paper or something or just
even one digital document on my computer
had i lost a document then well yeah
i would have lost it and i would have
had to begin from the absolute beginning
and this is the same thing for your code
[Music]
so you need to use two services called
git and github in order to
store your
code
in in a safe place so that you can
always retrieve it later
so let's talk quickly about what is git
and why do you need this um
so what you need to know about gitz is
that git is a
piece of software on your computer
that allows you to
manage
various changes that you make to a code
base such as our project at different
times keeping track of the date those
changes were made the person who made
the changes and the changes themselves
and also it will be able to provide you
the difference between your recent
changes and what was already
provided in the or what was already
committed into this git repository
well what a git repository really is is
a bucket
is an empty bucket initially where there
is nothing in there and as you interact
with your source code then you'd be like
okay now i want to turn this source code
that i've written into a bucket so then
there's a bucket created around your
source code called a git repository
which keeps track of all the changes
that you're that you're making or
anybody else that works on the same
source code is making to the code and it
will allow you to save snapshots of
those changes at
at specific times of your choosing
if you're a designer of your and you're
working with
figma for instance figma already
automatically saves your work at the
times that it sees fit so you never have
to press really a save button and also
figma if you've seen it
and it keeps track it has a version
history so you can literally go to figma
and say okay i've done my work i want to
actually commit my changes in the
version history and i want to give it a
name
most designers don't do that and they
legislate must save their work
automatically and by that figma just
says here's the timeline of your changes
at this time you did this at this time
you did this so
even if you're a designer you're
implicitly using something called a
version control and which in it in that
case is figma
but when you're coming to the software
development world we're working with
your flutter application there is no
figma there and you're working with raw
code so you're going into visual studio
code or sublime or whatever text editor
that you're using android studio
as an id or whatever
then there is no service sitting there
and saying oh you made some changes let
me let me help you save it in some sort
of app
or a cloud solution so
the system that allows you to do that on
your computer is called git so git is a
software that allows you to keep track
of changes that you're making to source
code okay
so i can see here that before we
continue we're gonna actually talk a
little bit about git
and so
what i'm gonna do here i'm gonna add lib
a little bit here and improvise
and i'm gonna go here and make the
screen a little bit bigger i'm gonna
bring up terminal and you don't see it
on that screen because it opened on
another screen so
let me just increase the size and bring
it up here so you also see it
so i'm gonna go here to my development
folder
and i'm going to go to my projects and
let's think go to
make a folder i'm going to say git
okay
should i call it git or just let's
actually create a folder called
testing okay
let's go into testing then it is an
empty folder as you can see for now
and what we're going to do is we're
going to tell git now which is a
software installed on my computer um to
tell it that okay all of a sudden i want
to turn this empty directory here into
something called a repository remember
it's going to be a bucket then that
keeps track of changes in the current
directory now before we continue maybe
oh sorry about that
maybe you also need to actually install
git on your computer if you're not
coming from a software development
background you probably don't even have
git installed on your computer so i'm
going to bring up a
a browser window here and say install
git
so
if i google install git you will see
that there there's like information
how you can install git on your computer
if you
are on a macintosh and you have already
installed xcode xcode comes pre pre like
pre-packaged with gits already
if you're on windows i believe that you
actually have to i have a windows
machine right here next to me which i
use daily i believe for windows you'll
have to install git personally like
manual so let's say install git
windows
uh get download package get a time get
guys install git
oops my ipad for some reason got
disconnected here so i'm going to have
some difficulty then
um
let's see now install git on linux
okay
i believe there is a good package
actually for getting it on windows let
me go back here installer on windows you
can see here
just go to i'm going to increase the
screen size a little bit as well so you
can see it a little bit better
here it says go to https get scm com
download win so i'm going to go here
and it's going to start downloading so
i'm just going to say cancel because
right now i'm in a macintosh so here is
where you can download git and install
it on your computer
if you are on a windows machine and you
have the linux subsystem which i do on
my windows machine then you may actually
want to download git using see sudo apt
um
on that
linux subsystem but
it is possible that the linux subsystem
on windows already comes shipped with
git so you don't have to do anything i
wouldn't be surprised if git was one of
the absolute core components that was
shipped with linux
um
so that's for a macintosh and also if
you're on a macintosh and you don't have
xcode for whatever reason
um
then you may need to also download git
separately so let's go back here and see
how you can do that
uh if you say mac os here it says there
are several ways to install get on mac
users probably install the xcode command
line tools which we've already done so
if you don't have it in slavery it will
prompt you to install it
so otherwise you can go in here get
semcom download mac and then you can do
brew install git
so if that is what you want to do then
you first have to actually install
homebrew
so
go into this link and say homebrew
install basically just do as it says
here you see there's the command
and then go and install
git using homebrew
and if you're on linux then a sudo apt
install git i think maybe you don't even
need to have sudo if you're installing
for the current user so just apt
app is it get or install i forgot but
there's information about
linux here as well
app install yeah get all
so
yeah i mean i'm assuming you're kind of
like on a debian based distribution as
well but otherwise there's information
here how you can install it otherwise so
all right uh
that was a lot of information and before
we continue i'm just going to try to
make sure that i'm connected back to my
uh
to my laptop to my ipad here because on
my ipad i keep hold of all the
information that i have to provide to
you in some sort of like a chronological
order so it is very important for me to
actually get my notes up there so i'm
going to try to connect to my ipad and
yeah there it is
okay
so
now that you've i'm assuming that you've
installed git i'm assuming that that is
done if you say which git
then it's going to tell me in this case
that user being get that's where get it
installed if you're on windows to be
honest with you i don't know the command
on windows to know whether it come like
git is installed but on windows all you
have to do is just to type git and if if
you see that
it throws an error it says git isn't
available either you haven't installed
git and if you have installed git maybe
git isn't in the current path so you'll
have to go and adjust your environment
variables in order to get git and
is lots of information on the internet
so we're not going to focus right now on
how to install git exactly because
that's going to be like its own course
maybe
but if you follow the instructions that
were provided on the website that i just
showed you should be able to get far
so
i'm assuming now git is is installed on
our computer and you can see here we're
in a folder called testing so if i say
where that testing is you can see that
is is right here now what we want to do
is to say testing for instance is the
project that we're gonna place all our
code in okay so there's gonna be
information that we're gonna write here
in this um in this folder there's gonna
be some dart files there's gonna be some
png and jpeg files there's gonna be our
application icon all that stuff
and we want to store this safely
so
the first thing you may want to do is to
to basically tell git that this current
directory in itself is a git's
repository so the bucket remember the
bucket is going to wrap itself around
the directory so
if i get the contents of this directory
at the moment you can see that it's
completely empty but if you want to
create a git bucket or a git repository
around this directory all you have to
say is just to say git init dots
okay
you'll see here now it says that
initialize amt git repository in this
folder
so now if i get the contents of this
folder you'll see that there is a new
directory called dot git and dot git
directory is where git basically keeps
track of its internal like the changes
to this directory and like
what you
save when you save it who is it that
saved the work etc so now that you've
done that now you've created a git
repository basically around this empty
directory you can issue various diff git
commands such as
its status
this will give you the current status on
this um
on this uh
directory and you can see here as soon
as we created a git repository with git
in it all of a sudden my terminal
changed my prompt here and said that all
of a sudden testing is not just testing
anymore but it's actually a git
directory and we're on a branch called
main
now
i don't want to talk about branches
right now but just know that there are
um
yeah let's just not talk about branches
right now because i'm planning to do
that a little bit later so
so but what we are going to talk about
is this little message here that says no
commits yet now
in git whenever you're working um git
doesn't just save your work
automatically you need to tell git to
save your work and those points where
you save your work there are call
commits it commits as its name indicates
is you committing your work you say i
committed to this and i want to save it
and that's i mean it could be called
save but save is
maybe
um
it could be uh like
read as kind of more like a verb like oh
am i gonna save it now or what is it but
if i say here's my commit then
it could be a little bit easier to infer
that oh it's a piece of information that
you've saved and you've committed to so
i think maybe that's the reason it's
called the committee i'm not sure
so
those commits are points of time where a
person that has access to this
repository saved their work okay so just
remember that that is a commit and if we
see here the status says no commits yet
because there was literally nothing that
you told get to save now what we're
going to do is to open up visual studio
code so i'm going to bring up you just
to studio code here and you can see it's
an empty folder
and i'm gonna create a file here and
let's just call
um let's call this um
info.txt so just text file okay
so here's an empty file and i'm just
gonna type hello in here increase the
size a little bit as well so you can see
better
so
now if i say git status here you can see
all of a sudden it doesn't say no
commits yet it it well basically it says
dad but it also says on track files and
it puts the info text right here now
let me then explain what attract file
and on track file is a track file is a
file that you've told git about before
so it it's tracking the changes being
made to that file
on track file is a file that you have
not told yet before about so it says oh
here's a file you're doing something
with it but i'm not gonna even look at
it i'm not gonna keep track of it
because you don't you didn't tell me to
do so
so
and things um
i mean yeah a file basically can be in
three states in git right now you've
learned two of them either tracked or on
track but it could also be in another
state that i will show you soon
so
now you can see there's a message here
that it says let me bring actually the
terminal a little bit up here so you can
see the terminal in its entirety it says
use git add and then the name of the
file in order to include what will be
committed so let's do that i'm just
going to say git add info txt
and now i'm going to say git status and
all of a sudden you'll see that get
understood that here's a new file you're
committing committing this file
called info text but you can see
that it still says you haven't committed
anything but it says changes to be
committed and all of a sudden this file
is green
remember i said a file can be in three
states on tracked which means git
doesn't know about it tracked which
means it does know about it or it could
be staged
so if you see here this file is green
and it says changes to be committed so
stage is where
you have made changes to a file
and you've told git that you want to
commit it but you haven't committed it
yet
now you may be asking okay why would i
have files that aren't going to be
committed in some projects if you have
some information for instance if you're
working with 10 other developers
and you're making some
tests and you're writing some code in
the in the directory where your source
code is placed at but you don't you're
not really ready with that file yet you
don't want to commit it into a branch
where everyone else sees then you could
say oh i'm not going to commit this it
is not staged file i'm not even ready
for staging it and putting it into the
commit so in that case you're not going
to add it to the staging area okay so
remember that
now that you've you've done that you
just said git add you can commit it and
a commit literally means that you're
going to save this work in git okay
and the way to do that is using git
commits
and then you will provide a message
using dash m here and then quotation
marks okay so here you will write a
message that will be appended to your
entire commit
so what we're going to do here says
let's just say
add new info txt file for fun okay and
then i'm just going to press enter
and see here it says one file change and
one insertions and it will say that yeah
it has created this file okay so i'm
gonna clear my uh terminal now and we're
gonna do git status
all of a sudden that message that about
no commits yet disappeared and all this
is is that is that you're on a branch
called main and there's nothing to
commit okay
so
what do you do then if you want to see
the commit that you just made like if
you want to see okay what are all the
comments that were made then in that
case you can say git log
and git blog will display
all the all the commits that were made
and who they were made by and you will
also be able to see the date that were
made and the commit message do you
remember we said git commit dash m so
that was the message provided in the get
command and then saved in the repository
okay
so
that is the message and that's the email
of the person who basically did that
commit
now i jumped over a little bit here and
um
and to be honest with you that was
i didn't really think about that some
people if you're installing git
then you're not going to have all this
information already set up like who you
are
and there's information about how you
configured it and how you tell get who
you are
and what your name is etc and that is
using a command called git config
and global for instance
but you could actually read about read
about that online so just say git config
and then you will get a lot of
information about how to do that so but
just know that git is such a big world
that if i want to explain everything
about git we could have a course that is
already
30 hours just talking about git so
just know that there's constraints for
on me to explain like the absolute
basics of get to you in order for us to
be able to use git in this course for
this particular use case so i'm gonna
just focus on those things okay so
um now that you know how to commit i
think you're
you're like very
you're in
good
place to start learning more about git
and the thing you may want to know so
which we're not going to use in our in
this course
is branch using git and why you'll need
them now
git is a
is a piece of software that allows
groups of people work on the same piece
of code without losing their changes now
if you're for instance from a design
background if you're working with figma
if i go into the design file that you
you've shared with me as an observer i
cannot make any changes so i can only
observe you and i can just like export
assets uh or even if you're using um a
zeppelin
it's the same thing you can so someone
some designer sitting with sketch for
instance and then they're exporting the
work into zeppelin and then you as an
observer you're
you're exporting that information from
zeppelin
but you can't make any changes to the
source however with git when you share
your information for like your git
repository with someone else they can
also make commits to it as you'll see
soon we're going to use github for that
so
um
then basically you need to
make sure that every person is
identified correctly and then they have
for instance they
that they have configured get in the
right way and sometimes
i mean we're talking about branches so
sometimes these people
don't want to affect what you are doing
in this main branch so just imagine and
a branch is more like a
train line like your train is going
there
and maybe some some places your friends
want to visit a town in the city that
you hadn't planned so they get off the
train they go on another train line and
at the end you will meet so at that
point you can see that they branched out
into their own branch and that is like
the concept of branches in git as well
so sometimes when you're working with
other developers they may want to branch
out into their own branches on the same
source code do some experiments and once
they figure out what they actually
wanted to do maybe they will save their
own work into that branch and then they
will bring it back to your branch at the
end you will meet at the train station
and then they bring the results with
them and then you merge together so
there's a lot of information about
branches how they work in kit but just
know that
branches are kind of like train lines
and right now you're on the main train
line
going from your city to the destination
okay
so
um but again there's time constraints on
this course i can't explain everything
about git but if you're interested
there's lots of great content available
on youtube that you can watch and i'm
pretty sure that there's lots and lots
of tutorials online as well that you can
go and read about as well
wow that was a lot of information okay
um
let's now talk about what github is
now
github is simply said a cloud service
for storing your git repositories so
um
right now this git repository is sitting
on my computer so even if if it is i'm
committing my work i'm saving my work
there's still
no uh traceability from the outside
world so no one else is allowed to see
this code right now it's sitting right
on my computer and for that if i want to
share this code with other people and
potentially allow them not to read only
but also to be able to commit and
collaborate with me in the source code
then i would be able to share that on a
cloud service such as github
github
has the word git in its name but it's
not the same thing as git so git is a
software that actually manages all your
commands and etc but github is the cloud
service that holds on these repositories
for you
so
if you don't have a github account i'm
going to help you do that right now
so
let me close actually no i'm not going
to close i'm going to minimize this
and minimize perhaps um
yeah let's close this one i don't think
we're gonna need it
so i'm gonna bring up a window here
and i'm gonna go here and
look at this
website github.com all right
so
what we need here is that for you to
create a github account and to do that
you'll need to go to
this website that i will provide for you
right there github.com sign up okay
so i'm gonna if i bring up um
a browsing window here and say sign up
you will see that yeah it won't know
that i'm signed in already with my other
account and it will ask me to start
signing up right here okay
so this is like the main window for the
sign up of github and this they've done
it a little bit comically it kind of
like a star wars kind of theme i don't
know what you want to call it but
here you will go through a few steps in
order to create a github account okay
so
i'm not going to do that simply because
i've already done that
but in your case we'll just need to go
through this provide your email choose a
good secure password for your email for
your github account and then at the end
you will have a simple github account
okay
as i already have
so
uh
we've talked about already setting up
git in the terminal so i'm not gonna
talk about that i'm just gonna maybe
move this
um a little bit up all right
now after you've set up github on your
uh basically after you set up a github
account
you will need to set up something called
ssh keys now
this is a little bit technical but
and it is nothing that you can jump over
it's not like you can actually commit
your work without setting up ssh keys on
your computer you can always go to
github and actually commit your work
right on github itself like you can
write some text and then
change that
text right in the github interface like
the web interface so
then they will do all of that work for
you because they will commit it from
kind of like their key their own ssh
keys i believe but if you on your
computer want to be able to commit your
work from your
hard disk or your ssc or whatever into
github you will need something called
ssh key ssh keys are
cr crypto cryptograph crypt
how should i say it
is cryptographically even uh
let's see crypt
cryptographic
no crypt
yeah cryptographically i don't know
yeah cryptographically signed
these are cryptographically signed
pieces of
signature
um that
will
just kind of like private keys that we
worked with when we worked with keychain
in one of the previous chapters
they allow you to identify yourself as a
person or as a committer
so
i think that does make sense
uh i apologize again for the hiccup of
cryptographically it's just because i'm
not a native english speaker so you
should be expecting these hiccups
every now and then at least
so
an ssh key is a piece of key that is a
signature that you as a developer or a
committer of code create on your
computer
and whenever you make a commit and you
wanna
send that commit then to
github then github
knows who you are
okay so it says okay
you are
person xyz and you're trying to push
your changes into this repository i'm
just gonna make sure you have access to
everything okay
so you need your ssh key set up
so
what we need to do is to go to github
and i'm going to bring up a web browser
for you to understand how to set up your
ssh keys so let's say github sets up ssh
keys
and you can see adding a new ssh key to
your github account so there is a very
very comprehensive guide here on how to
set up your ssh keys so you can see that
it says
um
let's see
generating a new ssh key and adding it
to the ssh agent so this is where you
want to go okay
so after searching for github as a setup
ssh keys make sure that you at the end
go to this link generating a new ssh key
and adding it to the ssh ssh agent
read through this there is very
comprehensive guide there are only a few
commands that you have to issue in the
terminal so
do them precisely as as it is specified
here okay
so after you've done that then what
you'll need to do is
to add that ssh key i believe into your
github account you see as the link
provides here adding a new ssh key to
your github account so
you can see here then it says okay do
this command and then go to your github
account settings and then go to search
and gpg keys and then say new ssh key
and then add that information in here
okay and then press save
and that's it then you have your ssh key
all set up and done so these are the two
things you'll need to do create an ssh
key and then upload the public key into
github
and again because of constraints on this
course i can't explain this
like line by line to i'm just providing
you the information that you need to
know and i kind of expect you to do
these things on your own okay
um
so
that is that now
we also need to talk about um
gpg keys
uh
and let's actually i think gpg was new
privacy
what was jpg
privacy guard
so is a piece of software that you
download on your computer you can see is
a free software replacement for
semantics pgp cryptographic software
suit
uh it is compliant with rfc blah blah
all you need to know about gpg and how
we're going to use it in this course is
that
um
where you
have your i mean we talked about ssh
keys where you have your ssh keys and
then you and i know this is a little bit
geeky but that's kind of like the nature
of this thing anyways
and when you
sign your commits with your ssh key with
your private key and then you push your
changes to github and github just
verifies okay this is a
this commit is coming from someone who
has access to this repository
when you create your
gpg keys and then you sign your commits
with the gpg keys
then that actually verifies that you are
who you say you are so a lot of software
developers are still continuing with ssh
keys and to be honest with you that's
not good enough
um
[Music]
i mean
well it it depends kind of on your
opinion but in my opinion is not good
enough because anybody getting a hold of
your ssh keys can literally just do
anything they want with your commits and
change anything they want but um
with the gpg keys you'll ensure that you
are who you are and anyone else even if
they have hold of like your ssh keys
their their commits won't be signed as
you so
um
so let's now talk a little bit and we're
going to take some items here and just
make sure that we've talked about them
about ssh keys
now we're going to talk about gpgm where
you actually need it so there's a little
link here
i'm going to open that link here so we
can both see it and it says git is
cryptographically
uh
still i this word is a little bit
different different for me to say
cryptographically secure but it's not
foolproof if you're taking work from
others on the internet and want to
verify that commits are actually from a
trusted source git has a few ways to
sign and verify work using gpg okay
so
uh
so what you'll need to do is uh you need
to set up jpg basically on your computer
and i and i believe
um if you just say gpg install mac or
gpg install windows or whatever then you
can come to for instance for i'm using
jpg tools on mac
and for you can actually install gpg for
various operating systems for instance
windows or linux so just google gpg and
then your operating system is so for
instance gpg
i can smell as spell
if i can smell
gpg and download noon pg here and you
see so this is like the download tools
for
windows i believe let's see
and you can see here you could use
gpg for win
full featured windows version of you
know pg so
all i'm trying to say is just to
download the piece of software called
gpg for your operating system so whether
it's gpg for win or
gpg tools for mac os or if it's like for
debian uh
canoe pc is part of debian okay so it's
already maybe built in so you don't have
to do anything for
your debian based linux operating
systems
all right
so after doing that then you will need
to
set up gpg for github and i'll provide a
link here for you that you can
read about says managing commit
signature verification
and the link i'll open it here
so you can see how it looks like
and you can see here
generating a gpg key so you can first go
there and it will help you through the
various steps that you need to take in
order to create your gpg keys it's very
easy it's just a few lines of uh
code or a few lines of text that you
have to issue in your terminal in order
to create your gpg keys okay
so after you've done that and
you need to make sure to go into this
section add a new gpg key we've done
that
and then you go here to your settings
you can see ssh and gpg keys and then
the same way you added your ssh keys
you'll need to add the gpg key in your
github account okay
and after you've done that the
difference between sshk and a gpg key is
kind of like to you need to tell get
that you have a gpg key and then it
needs to sign your commits with your gpg
key okay
and that's where you go into this tell
get your assigning key and you need to
just follow these steps to tell get
using the
git config global user signing key you
see here okay
so just follow these steps to be honest
with you i don't think you need to
associate email with gpg really right
now but if you want to you can do that
so i'm kind of like assuming that you've
already done that
for
um
for your computer and that you've
created the ssh key you kind of know a
little bit about git you have a github
account now you have created your pgp
keys and then you have told git about
your pdp key so your signature comments
are actually signed okay
so the next thing we need to do is to
now can you see we've been working on
our um
notes application my notes i think it
was the
um
the project was called my notes here
if you remember
and um
if i say git status here you will see
that it says not a git repository and
that's kind of a little bit sad because
we've written quite a lot of code but we
haven't really backed it up in github
okay
so
what we need to do now is to go and
create a github repository remember that
bucket we need to create one of those
buckets for our code
so let's go i'm going to create a safari
window here or
chrome or brave
firefox whatever you want to use and i'm
going to go to github.com
and i'm going to go into repositories
here as you can see and i'm going to say
new
and i'm going to give it the name my
notes all right i'm going to increase
the size of the window so you see it
better for the description i'm going to
say my notes flutter application
and you can see here that tells you it
asks you if you want to create a public
public repository or a private
repository and the difference here is
that if you create a public repository
everyone can by default read
the content that you're creating
usually
if if you're if you're not 100 sure what
public means create a private repository
because
usually there's lots of information that
you may want to create like a private
information with some api keys
so you want to probably create a private
repository unless you know exactly what
you're doing or if you want to for
instance um
contribute to open source projects and
create an open source project from an
absolute beginning then you go and
create a public but you can always make
your private repository public later
and you can always make your public
repository private later but that
doesn't happen that often so
it's probably a good idea to create a pr
private in the beginning okay
then in here add a readme file a readme
file is pretty much just a file that
will be displayed to whoever goes to
your github repository and looks at just
the index file of the github repository
so you can place some information in
there but it's usually a good idea to do
that you don't have to but i suggest
that you actually do that and then say
excuse me
and then say add git ignore and we
haven't talked about git ignore before
but what get ignore is that its name
indicates is a file that dictates to get
on your computer
or on the computer of whoever has cloned
your repository about what files should
not be committed to your git repository
so
usually it's a good idea to have a get
ignore file and in here for the template
just choose dart okay
dart
okay
and in here you don't have to choose
license right now because you're
probably not going to share this code
with anybody as it is right now but you
can always add a license later okay
so
i created a private repository some name
uh which is my notes sorry yeah um
i actually feel no for the name of the
repository i'm going to change it just
to lower in case i have no space it's
just my notes okay
and then i'm going to say create
repository boom
so as you've done that now you will see
that you have a repository here
and
i mean there's nothing really in it okay
so
what we need to do now is to you see we
have
our code here and then we have a
repository how do we put this code in
there you may think okay i'm going to
upload all the files by hand or like go
and drag files here
you could kind of actually do that but
it's not a good idea
and so what you need to do is just tell
git now all of a sudden that hey
this
folder here is indeed a git repository
remember from what i said before so you
need to say git init
i'm going to bring up the caption so you
know what i'm talking about git init and
then you say good and it dot okay all of
a sudden this became a repository so if
you do get status you see
let me see if i can actually change the
arrangement on the screen so you'll see
more of the
screen real estate
and perhaps i could even do something
like this
is that a better idea than just doing
this
no probably not so this is better
uh okay this is a little bit better so
you see now it says now that you're a
git repository i can see you have a lot
of files that you haven't really
committed and what we could do then we
could say git add
all
add all these files and folders to my
git repository and then i'm going to say
git commit
with the m as a message my initial
commits okay
see now if i say git status it says
there's nothing to commit
i want to kind of push these changes i
want to send these changes together but
how do i do that because if i say git
push
see it says oh i don't know where to
push these things to
so
what you need to do now is to go to your
github repository and then go to code
and then grab this guy from here
you see to the code to ssh
and then copy this and then go in here
and do what it says here git remote ad
so i'm going to say git remote add
origin it's the name of our remote for
instance and now i'm going to add that
if i say git push
it says okay now that you've done that
you still need to tell me that this main
branch which is on your local computer
is actually mapping to the main branch
on github which is right here
so you see here's the main branch and
we're also on the main branch so
you don't have to do this complicated
code you could actually say git push you
origin head which to me is a little bit
cleaner
and that will do the same thing for you
updates were rejected because the remote
contains work that you do not have
locally this is usually because it's
actually great that we got this
i had a plan for this to happen but what
is happening here is that you see if i
go into this
github repository
and then
i can click on this initial commit here
you will see that when i created the
repository and we chose all those you
know readme file and the
and the git ignore file these are files
that are literally created on github
using github by github and placed inside
this repository so that is a commit you
see it has its own
and
it has its own commit id
now
that commit is sitting there in that
bucket over here so there's a commit in
its own bucket okay now we have our own
computer here with its own bucket
and its own commit but all of a sudden
we're telling this using that git add
command that i said
what we're doing is that we're we're
making a connection between this local
repository and the server repository and
saying that any changes have happened
here we want to push them over here and
when we said git push
these changes are rejected because it
says oh you're you have changes here
and commits and you're putting them in
here
but
your changes your repository here didn't
contain the changes that were already
there so it's saying that there's a
conflict i don't know what you're trying
to do are you trying to like replace the
contents that were over there with your
stuff
and to be honest with you that could
actually be the case
because
you see what we did here we have a git
ignore file here that was created for us
by github and also we have our readme
file which we probably actually don't
need to be honest with you maybe we
don't need that and also they get
ignored but if you looked at the changes
that were committed committing here if i
say
um
lsla
you will see there already is a file
here
it was called get ignore
here you see
which was created by flutter when we
created our project flutter already
added that so let's say cat
and with ignore to see its contents and
you'll see there's lots of stuff that
fluffer has already created for us that
says these things need to be ignored so
what i'm trying to say is that all these
things that exist over here we don't
need them really so what you could do is
say git push
f
and i believe that force pushes a bit
push
u origin
head f
which force pushes everything
okay
so i'm going to clear that now and i'm
going to go to my notes repository and
all of a sudden you see that
here is you see
and oh we already had a readme file as
well so flutter has created a readme
file that's that's amazing i didn't know
this so i learned something that's
pretty cool
all right there we go so now we have our
code basically pushed
[Music]
um so that is for our commit
that is already
placed there
i'm gonna just take some items here that
i've talked about them
um
great
so that is already done as well pushing
so now you have your changes over there
okay on github
now what we need to talk about is also
tagging
in this course i'm going to use a
feature in git called tags
a tag is just as its name indicates it
kind of is a label
so as you're as you become better and
better at software development you'll
understand that some places sometimes
during your journey as a software
developer the code that you wrote means
a special thing to you for instance you
may say
after a whole weekend of work i could
finally deliver like the verification
screen to my users and that in itself in
its essence essence has a special
importance is it has a special meaning
and you may want to tag it and by
tagging it it means that i'm just going
to give a special name to this so in the
future if i want to go back to that
point in time i don't go i don't have to
go into my be it log and look at all my
commits and see which one was that
special commit but i also want to like
give it a special name okay and that
name is a an annotated tag or a tag that
has a message applied to it all right
so
that is in its essence what tagging is
so you're giving a name to your um
to your uh work basically
so what we need to do now here is to tag
our work as step one we've done a lot of
steps up to this point but none of them
has been so
like important that we actually have to
commit yet but i think this is important
enough now we have a registry screen and
a login screen so that we can tag it so
the way to create it to create an
annotated tag and git you will literally
just say git tag okay
so
let's go in here and say git tag and
give it the name of step one
all right now you can see if i want to
push these tags to the back end sorry to
github because those tags don't exist
right here right now
and
what we could do is to say git push tags
dash tags and this pushes all those tags
to the server
which is github in that case
and to be honest with you i don't really
know here one tag i can see all of a
sudden here
tags and step one is created there okay
so what we could do also is that's after
we have our gpg keys all set up we also
can confirm that our work is truly
signed
and if i go to my notes here and then
look at this commits
um
let's see if you can see that
information
somewhere here can we see all our
commits
um somehow here
if you go to this timeline
oh it's not showing me that information
right now
yeah but anyways you could you could
have a look at whether your commits are
signed by a little badge which i can't
see right now so maybe there's actually
something wrong with my pgp key so if
you've done all the pgp installation
correctly on our computer then you
should see all your commits being signed
and actually displayed here but with
some sort of a badge but i can't
unfortunately see that maybe github has
changed that interface so that we can't
see our verified and badge for our jpg
keys yet so
all right we talked a lot about
gits in this chapter
um so i think that's actually quite
enough for this chapter and git we've
talked almost 15 minutes about get to be
honest with you and that's sufficient
now that we've got get set up what we're
going to use it for in the upcoming
chapters is whenever we do something
significant that needs to be saved we
are going to commit that change and also
tag it and send both our commits and our
tag
to github so that is stored securely in
some sort of a cloud storage basically
so
that's how we're going to use git and
github in this course
and i thought of it as so important for
every software developer to know that i
thought if anybody is watching this
course who is not a software engineer in
front before
then you definitely need to know about
git and github before you can continue
so what we're going to do in the next
chapter then is to talk about email
verification we've done login register
screen is very simple but we haven't
done the email verification yet and
that's exactly what we're going to do in
the next chapter so i'll see you there
hello and welcome to chapter 16 of the
swata course
in the previous chapters we've talked
about the login and registration page
and also we took a little detour to talk
about
git and github
so now you should have all those things
set up so you should also have some sort
of an emulator simulator or real device
setup so we're testing our application
right from visual studio code or android
studio or sublime whatever text everyone
on those devices
um in this chapter we're going to as the
caption says here we're going to talk
about email verification
and um
i talked about this in the
in
one of the previous chapters why we need
email verification
but the main reason for that is as you
can see in the caption here says people
can sign up with emails they don't own
and that is a little bit of a problem
and
um
the reason why it
is a problem is that you might
get into a situation actually i can see
here my wi-fi is kind of tripping
okay it's connected now sorry about that
and
what could happen is if a user comes in
to the application and starts your
flutter application on their phone or
tablet and then they sign up with an
email that they don't own and then i as
the rightful owner of that email address
come to and download the same
application and try to register my email
and the applications as well this email
address already exists
so
um so we have a problem here so what we
need to make sure is that the p people
who register in an email can also verify
that they own that email address okay
so let's take care of that in this
chapter
gonna bring up visual studio code or you
also bring up the
editor of your choice where you're um
the editor that you're comfortable with
um
and i'm just gonna take in my notes that
i've talked about that
so what we're gonna do here as the first
step is to go to our main dart file here
right after home page and create a state
full widget i believe
so
i'm going to do that right now so
sd remember sdf stateful
then we're going to call let me see
verify
email view
all right
and in here uh what we're gonna do
is just to return a simple scaffold so
i'm just gonna say return scaffold for
now we're gonna get a cons error here so
i'm just gonna
put the constant there
so
um that's for our stateful widget
then what we're gonna do is um
we are as you can see here as soon as we
see that um the email isn't verified
here we just say you are sorry that it
is verified we say you are a verified
user and if you're not verified we just
say you need to verify your email first
but in both cases what we're doing is
that we're just returning a text widget
that says done and it's displayed here
and so what we need to do here
is
to if the user is verified
in here we're going to say return this
otherwise what we need to do is to
display this verify email view okay
but
the way we need to do this right now and
we're actually going to fix this quite a
lot as we go on but right now i just
want to show you how to push a view into
the screen now pushing is a concept that
i believe came
came into
like a widespread existence after ios
and android became popular in the early
days of like 2006 2007
actually was 2007 i think
and pushing is where you have a screen
and you're seeing that screen and then
you press a button or something and
another screen just kind of pushes
itself on top of the existing screen
okay
so what we need to do now is to
if we see that well you haven't
verified your email you want to push
this verify email view and a way to do
that in um flutter
is with something called a navigator and
remember this is a little bit
problematic the thing that we're gonna
do right now is actually gonna cause an
error and i will explain all this but
for now let's just go go ahead and do
this so we will fix things as we go on
okay
so
right here that where we say you need to
verify your email first and we can
actually see that in the console um
here um oh you can't see it because it's
hidden by
the caption but you can see now it says
you need to verify your email first
so let's go ahead and
push that
verify email view onto the screen what
i'm going to do i'm going to get rid of
this so um
make the
uh
what should i do here should i go back
to the same layout so you can see yeah
that's probably better so go in here and
say navigator
off
and
then you say your build context and then
you should say push
now push is the function that you're
calling
and
you can see here it acts it says okay
give me
a route
and then you say material routes here
um material page route
okay and then there's a builder function
in here
and um
like this i will explain all of this
soon to you and then in here say verify
email view
just like that
um
we have to return
all of this
and i think we're
there's something wrong with all this
let's see builder and then we're doing
that and then one parenthesis i think is
missing is it
so this one closes there
then there's this one
and it needs to be ruined and what is
the actual error that's being displayed
the return time future dynamic isn't a
widget as required okay
and uh what we need to do is just to do
this
and yeah that's fine so let's bring this
return done back to where it was and
then we remove this print statement from
here as well and this print statement
from there and make this cons and i'm
gonna explain all of this so don't worry
about it
all right so
what is happening here is as you can see
sorry about that my throat isn't really
working with me today
so what is happening here is
you see in our future builder here
we are expected in the builder function
which we are right now in here you see
we're always expected to return a widget
so that's what the future builder does
it is in itself a widget
that performs a feature and once that
future is done or it errors out or
whatever
then it calls this builder function and
in the builder function it is expected
to return that builder function itself
is expected to return a widget
something to display on the screen okay
now your job as a developer who's using
the future builder is to actually return
a widget in this builder function and
that's why we're doing here what we're
doing here we're saying if the
connection state if the future is done
return this text of done
otherwise return this text so we have
basically
fulfilled the contractual um
agreement here
builder expects a widget we return a
widget however we're trying to be clever
here in saying that okay we do return
done but also we're performing an action
which is navigator of this context which
is our build context and we haven't
talked about build context so much
before but you can actually see
i mean the documentation isn't so clear
maybe it says this class presents a set
of methods that can be used from build
methods and from
but anyways what a build context is is
kind of like a packaged bit of
information that you can you can use in
order to pass data from one widget to
the other and it is very useful for for
instance if you're using block and we
haven't talked about block yet but just
know the build context is kind of like a
bit of information about the context
where your widget
is at
so in here what we're saying we're
saying create a navigator of this
context and navigator is just a class
for you okay and then when you tell
navigator to push something it says okay
what do you want me to push on the
screen then we say create a material
page route
to push
and you can see that material page route
has an argument called builder which
in itself expects a widget okay so you
need to return a widget
in this build function but all we're
doing here to be honest with you it's
just saying that push a widget on the
screen that's all so this is like the
format that you need to learn about okay
navigator of the context push material
page route builder context and then you
put your widget in there
okay
all right that was a lot of information
i mean this looks kind of okay at the
moment
so
however there is a problem with it and
if you're not careful you can miss that
problem and i really always like to
bring up my
debug console so that i'm aware of all
problems that might happen and the
problem that you can see on the screen
it said
on handle exception package flutter
widgets navigator dart failed assertion
line blah blah in navigator
so that there is an error
[Music]
and um
there is actually a github issue for
that i can see i've actually linked it
there as well but we're going to come to
that but just be aware that what we are
doing here is not really good
it's not a good idea to push something
inside a future builder but we're going
to do it anyways just so we can fix it
later so that you know at least this
issue exists and at the same time we
achieve what we're trying to do here
which is displaying a new widget
once a condition is met in this case the
user's email is not verified okay
all right
what we need to do now is fix this up
fix our
widget up here
i'm gonna just take some items in my
notes
alright so
at the moment our
uh verify email view
it it's it's a completely wide scaffold
it doesn't even have an app bar there's
nothing in there so what we can do is
just to first of all go and create an
app bar here so we say app bar
and app bar title
we've done this before so you should
know already the syntax and then the
title is just gonna say verify
email verify email
and i can see appbar title is text i
don't even know what i've done wrong
here to be honest with the constraint
isn't the cons instructor it just means
that well okay i have to remove this
and i have to make this text const
um i mean
i'm i'm like moving past these things
but you may be a little bit confused if
you're not if you haven't done this
before you may be confused what i'm
doing here let's maybe i should explain
actually this what is happening here you
see
before we started using the app bar in
scaffold everything was completely fine
dart was completely okay and i said okay
i'm gonna accept this as it is what
we're telling dart here is that we're
creating a scaffold and it is a constant
scaffold it means it is we're not
actually doing any special configuration
that makes this not a constant okay but
that's so let's actually go here i'm
going to hold down command on my
macintosh you can hold down control your
linux machine or windows and click on
scaffold
excuse me
and you can see that the initializer
that i'm calling here or the constructor
that i'm calling here is marked as const
here okay
but as soon as we put app bar in here
and i'm going to click on the same thing
again let's see
if we can find that initializer
scaffold app bar this app bar i can't
really seem to find that particular
initializer
but what is happening
essentially here is saying that
um
what you're trying to do here which is
creating an app bar with a text inside
here a text widget and an app bar makes
this scaffold widget not a constant
anymore okay so
the first thing you need to do is say
okay i understand that that's not a
constant anymore remove this constant on
scaffold but then you get an error here
or
well a problem telling that okay you've
removed the comms from scaffold but
still you could make your code better by
making your text a constant because this
text scene text widget seems to be a
constant all right so i'm going to make
that a constant now
all right so back to our
so i'm going to press command s here
is not true and i'm going to hot restart
verify email okay and i can see we have
yeah it's
again we have a problem with hot reload
because as soon as we do hot reload then
we get this error but this error is
simply because of something weird that
we're doing in here so if you get error
just do hot restart and you should be
good to go until we fix this problem
okay
all right so as you can see in the
caption of this chapter what we need to
do here is to display a column text and
a text button to send the verification
email so let's go to the body of our
scaffold so i'm just going to say body
and let's create a column
children and inside the children
let's just go and say we have a text and
say please verify
your email address
and that's that and then what we're
gonna do in here we're gonna place a
text button as well
and perhaps what could be better
is
if i scroll this a little bit up so you
can see the code in its entirety
then the text button if you remember
from the previous chapters it has two
very important and required parameters
child and on press
according to darts
analysis tools or flutters analysis
tools
the child parameter of those widgets or
those functions that do accept the child
is preferred to always be the last
parameter so go ahead and create the
unpressed first and then go ahead ahead
and create the child so in the child
we're going to say text off
and send email verification
okay
and make this text content so dark is
happy about that and make this constant
as well press command s
and don't forget the comma here then hot
reload so we can see the results
okay so now we have some text in there
and then we have a button here that says
send email verification
okay i'm going to take it in my notes
that i've talked about that so we don't
miss it um
now what we need to do here is upon
pressing this button
we actually need to send an email
verification to the current user okay so
what we need is the current user so that
comes from let's see
if we can find it in our
login view and register view we have you
see login views or credentials firebase
code
um let's see actually we got the user
right here firebase initialize app and
then we were like fire yeah that's how
you get your current user firebase auth
instance current user okay so i'm going
to copy that information from our
home page okay and bring it into your
verify email view state in the button
press right there
so this is how you get your
user okay
now what we need to do is as the caption
says here we need to await on the user
send email verification so say await
user send
let's see
user send email verification okay so now
you can see this is a function
and it says it can't be unconditionally
invoked and that is because user can be
nil
or null
and it is an optional user so as you've
understood from the previous chapters
you need to conditionally
access this function now be a little bit
careful here because this function is a
future you see it's a future void so as
you know calling a function that returns
a future void does not invoke the future
except it only tells the function to
return the future okay so if you
actually want the future to be executed
you need to wait on it so if you then
say await here
you'll see we get an error telling that
yeah you can't do asynchronous call
calls in this current uh
scope that you're at and that is simply
because the unpressed function is not
marked as asynchronous okay so remember
that
great
so
um i'm gonna press command s here we get
the error i'm gonna do this hot restart
then
uh if i'm not mistaken i mean if i bring
a browser up let's see if i can bring a
browser window here and i'm going to say
console.firebase google
and let's go to our mynotes flatter
project and let's go and have a look at
our authentication i can see that
there's a user here it says
pixelityab.gmail.com for you it's
probably gonna say something else
hopefully it's gonna say something else
so that you haven't registered with my
email
and what we need to do then is to simply
go here and press the send email
verification button
boom
okay
so nothing happened on the screen
and um
i'm going to bring up the right caption
here so you know what we're talking
about now we want to kind of look at how
this email actually looks like
so let's see if i can bring up that
email without uh
without uh
i like bringing up all my
um
other emails and other users because
that's kind of like private information
so
all right so uh let's go ahead and see
i'm gonna then bring up this email on
the screen so you can see how it looks
like so
as as
that email address you can see here
that's my email address or this is the
user that is logged in into our
application then received an email from
firebase which is no reply at
mynotesflusterproject.firebaseapp.com
okay
and it says okay you need to click on
this link in order to verify your user
so
now
i'm just going to take in my actions in
my notes here that i've talked about
that
and let's then click on this link to
verify our identity and here it says
your email has been verified you cannot
sign in with your new account great okay
so i'm going to close that taking in my
notes that i've talked about it
um and what we can do here then is just
to
refresh here and there's nothing really
different about this user as you can see
so
um
we're also looking at that user and you
can't really i mean at the moment i
can't personally see if this user is
verified
or not so
maybe that's something that firebase is
going to provide in the future just like
a checkbox or something saying or like a
yeah just like a check icon saying
whether this user is verified or not but
you can't see that at the moment in
firebase console at least i can't
all right a lot of information now let's
go to our um
talk about this error that we got on the
screen
and i've provided a little link here
which i'm going to click on on a
separate screen and then bring it bring
it up here on the screen that you can
see
now if you remember where we pushed this
verify
email
widget on the screen
using navigator and then material page
route i think it's called
and where is it material page right here
do you remember
then we got this error on handle
exception okay and then there's an issue
actually for that here on
flutter's
github repository so as you know flutter
is an open source project and
is an organization here on github and
pretty much everything that they're
doing for flutter is under that
organization on github so as you can see
here it says how to call navigator push
in future builder error log and then
there's lots of great discussions about
like
what should be done and etc but
just know that for now what you need to
know is that you cannot do that without
having that error although although
things may seem fine in
on the screen but as you saw as soon as
you do a
hot
hot reload and then you will have this
error also so there is an exception
being thrown and we need to
handle that
all right so
after you've looked at that uh
github issue and you've gone through the
comments you'll understand that that's
not the way to do things in flutter at
least not for now
and um i'm actually gonna take it in my
notes so if you see me looking here i'm
just making sure that i'm explaining
everything to you okay
um
so what we need to do now is to go and
change the way our
um
our verify email view is created so
so instead of us returning
you see here what we're doing is that
we're in our verify email view what
we're returning we're returning an
entire scaffold and that is why we're
trying to push this screen on our
current home home page because we're
saying that here's the home page and
then there this is the verify email view
and it has a scaffold just like the home
page does do you remember if you go up
to our homepage homepage also has a
scaffold and an app bar so what we're
pretty much saying right now is that
this is the home page and we kind of
need to move another page on top of it
which pretty much has the same structure
it has the app parts etc etc
and that is causing the problem because
we're pushing something in future
builder and we're not allowed to do that
so
what you need to do now is
in order to fix this problem just for
now
we go and remove the scaffold and in our
build function all we're gonna do is
just to return the column okay so go on
your scaffold here and
here
and what we're gonna do is we're just
gonna say uh let's see if we have a
remove functionality here and we don't
and that's okay
i'm just going to grab this column
and i'm going to bring it a little bit
up so you can see i'm going to put a
comma here
hot hot reload so we don't see the ugly
error on the screen
and grab your column here
and without the comma at the end grab
that column and in the build function
just return that okay instead of your
scaffold and a semicolon at the end all
right
um
so that's what we're gonna do now
for now we're just gonna return column
there and then what we need to do
um
let me see actually that's what we're
gonna do now or is it something that
we're gonna do later
yeah
um
so yes
we've now changed verify email view and
that returns a column now let's go in
here you see in here when we see that
the user isn't verified uh what we need
to do then is to say navigator instead
of navigator of we're gonna just return
our verify email view in here okay so
let me go in here and just say return
that
as a constant
and in here
otherwise do that so i'm going to press
command s here
and a hot
reload
okay
so
let's go and see what is happening here
so what we're saying is that
if user instance current if user email
verified then return done otherwise
return verify email view so
what's happening to be honest with you
is that
previously where we were pushing an
entire screen on the current screen now
what we're doing is saying that here is
a screen already put this verify emails
email views widget
that returns that is returned from the
build function right inside this current
screen's content okay so it's a little
bit of a difference instead of pushing a
whole new screen we're putting that new
screen's contents in our screen all
right
okay and now we have this and i see now
that
our app still thinks that we're not
verified but what we could do is just to
make sure you can see here that
um at least we're not getting that ugly
error anymore so if i do a hot restart
here
i can see this email verification and
that's a little bit strange to be honest
with you because we did verify our user
so what i'm going to do is just to
ensure that this this phone right now
has
um
internet connection
and it does so that user should have
been verified
and i think we actually did click on the
verification email so let me go back
here
go back to the application
and what we could do is just to stop the
application from running and then press
run without debugging and just to ensure
that everything is set up correctly
so if everything is working fine then we
shouldn't come to
verify email view instead we should go
to
here
we should display the done text to the
to the user
so
let's just let's just ensure that that
is working as expected before we
continue with the next item
i can still see this and we could simply
put some um
poor man debugging in here and just
prints the user email like that prints
the entire
user to the screen command s okay
and let's go in here i can see email
verified is still false is anonymous
false metadata
last signing time so it still thinks
that i'm not verified so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to send an email
verification
and i'm just going to go to my mail here
and let me go here
and let's just i'm going to bring up
that email
and let me just ensure that
we can
click on that link
and it says your email has been verified
okay
then let's close this and i'm gonna do a
hot reload
here
and to be honest with you i can still
see now that we're not verified so
let's go in to safari
and say
um
firebase
flutter email verified not working
email verification
let's see if there's something that
we're missing
uh firebase auth current user and then
user null is email verified and i
believe that is what we're doing here it
this is not hopefully a future is
actually a user
yeah and
in here we're initializing the
application so that that should work
fine as well
and then we're getting the user and then
email verified that should also work so
um
one thing to implement is email verified
and initiate function imperiality can be
ideal approach to easy for verification
with firebase well that's not really
the problem here
connection state waiting
and it could simply be that we need to
just try to log in with that user so
that it tries to contact firebase again
okay
so
what i'm gonna do here is to as we have
planned here let's go and change both
the login view and the register view as
well so that they don't return
an entire scaffold but instead we're
gonna make sure that they only return
their actual content
okay as you can see i put in the caption
here that they shouldn't for now return
a scaffold
um
so that's going to be done in the home
page so let's go
and i can see i have a little bit of
them
now return a scaffold that's the
job of home page so i just fixed our
little caption there as well let's go to
login view and i'm gonna go here
and let's go to your login view here you
can see we have firebase initialize app
future builder we have all that logic
also in both login view and registering
we shouldn't be doing that so i'm gonna
grab this return column all the way from
there
and
go to all the way where the return
column ends
grab that then i'm gonna pretty much
nuke the entire
build function and instead return the
column okay so that's our login view
and now we have a lot of
unused imports i'm going to remove them
as well
and i'm going to go to our
register view and
for now as well do the same thing for
register view
go to your build function in the
register view and everything
needs to be removed except for the
actual content which is the column
so
grab the column as you can see here
nuke the entire build function
and just return your call all right
so what i'm gonna do here is
to
fix this email verification issue
perhaps what we need to do here
is
for now
let's go in here and
turn just comment out all the codes so
when the initialization of firebase is
done just return your login view so
let's say return
login view
okay as a constant so i'm just gonna
press command s and then we come here
and i'm going to enter pixelityab
gmail.com football baz okay
and if you remember from login view if
you go back to login view
we had this beautiful little thing that
printed the user credentials to the
screen so
that is saved already and i've saved
here as well
so let's go and enter that information
pixel tab at gmail.com and then through
bar bas
and let me bring up the debug console
and kind of change the screen layout so
so you see it a little bit better as
well i'm going to clear the console
and i'm going to press the login button
so
here now we have the user credential you
can see it's printed to the screen
and now email verified is set to true so
the problem there was that
when there's email verification sent
firebase
as you as a user i mean there's
something for me to learn as well so
i'm actually grateful that i'm learning
as i'm actually teaching
so
one once what happened here is that we
verified an email and that email
verification
we clicked on the link but firebase
doesn't immediately understand that
you've
as a user have verified your email now
so what you need to do you need to ask
the user to log in and upon that point
it seems like firebase is actually
refreshing that data locally as well as
contacting firebase backend and getting
the latest information from there so
just because your user has verified
their information doesn't mean that the
application is immediately going to
understand that so you need to ask the
user to log in again okay
so i can see here now we were supposed
to return the logging view um
so
i'm going to take some items in my notes
just to make sure that i've talked about
them
and we're returning the login view right
now from
from our home page so this is something
you'll need to do also before we
continue to the next chapter
all right that was a lot of information
and um
but
for this chapter
what we've done pretty much is just to
create the uh verify uh email view or
what we call it is it called verify
verify email view we ensure that it can
send an email we clicked on the link in
the email and made sure that the user is
verified and that's and that all has
been working fine
um
but we still have a lot to work on and
as you can see it right now i'm going
into the code and manually like
returning the screens that i personally
want to see or it's important for you to
see for instance the login view but
if you display login view how is the
user able to go from the login view to
register if they don't have an account
that they can log in with so that's what
we're gonna do in the next chapter we're
gonna create links between our screens
so that a user can go from one screen to
the other and then
back
so
um
so yeah great job that's it for this
chapter and i'll see you in the next one
hello and welcome to chapter 17 of the
slotted course
in the previous chapters we've been
working quite a lot with some of the
basics of flutter for instance stateful
stateless widgets we've been looking at
a column we've been looking at text
button and many other widgets and kind
of trying to get
our screens presentable to the user and
at the same time we've been working on
the functionality of the applications
such as logging in registering verifying
email etc
we have a lot to work on
and um we're gonna break it down by
first starting to work on the link
between the login and the register view
as you can see here
at the moment we i mean i'm going to
bring up the code um
the way we left it in the previous
chapter
as you can see here in the main function
sorry in our
home page widget and also let me change
the
um
let me change the structure on the
uh of the different views on the screen
so you can see a little bit better so if
i do a hot restart here you can see that
um when the connection state is done
when the firebase application is
initialized i'm displaying the or we're
displaying the login view here without
basically having the option to go to any
other screen from here so if i want to
send the user to the register view then
i have to change this code right here
and say okay now you have to
go to register view
so
that's why we need a link between these
two views i'm sorry i'm looking at this
screen just because i need to actually
ensure that i tick the items that i've
already explained so um we need to make
sure that when a user is on the login
screen even if that's the first screen
that we always display to the user which
is not
but if even if it was we need to be able
to let the user to go from the login
screen to the registry and also from
registry view back to the login screen
so that's what we're gonna do in this
chapter
so
as the first
item that we have to tackle
is to go to our login view and add a
button that will send us to
the registry so i'm going to open up
i'm going to bring it here make the
screen a little bit smaller here
so let's go to our login view which i
can see is actually modified um yeah
that's okay actually so
and what we need here you can see we
have a text button and that is for our
login view the login button
and as you can see the cache has added
text but it's allowing you to send us a
registry view so right after this text
button let's create a new text button
and i'm going to bring it a little bit
higher so you can see i'm going to say
text button remember uh child parameter
always has to be at the la at the
it should be the last parameter so i'm
going to say unpressed ask visual studio
code to complete it for me and then i'm
going to say child the text is going to
say what should it say
should it say not registered
yet
and we say register here something like
this i make it a constant okay
and i'm gonna save this and you can see
now that we have a little button here
that says not registered yet register
here
okay so that part is done but the button
at the moment the way it is right now
it's not doing anything so
we need to address that
but before we can do that we need to
talk about
named routes
you see in the previous exercise or in
the previous chapter
we use navigator and
dot of context and push
and then we created a material page
route
that may have all been kind of like
alien to you and you didn't really know
what was happening and that's okay you
will get to know it more and more as we
go through the various chapters in this
in this course but what we need to do
here is to first talk about what a route
is and what a name route is and i've
actually put a link to a documentation
here for you
that we can go i'm going to bring up my
web browser and i'm going to create a
new window and i'm going to say flutter
mean routes
which is going to end up in the exact
same link that you can see there
and it says here in the navig in the
navigate to a new screenplay recipe
however if you need to navigate to the
same screen actually it wasn't such a
great description to be honest i was
kind of expecting a little bit of better
description but maybe i can do that
myself instead of you having to look at
this and i can see to be honest with you
this
webpage is a part of a cookbook which
kind of is probably all
like linked together so in order for you
to understand this page you actually
have to go to this link and read that
and then see
and then this would be the continuation
so
i just put the link here just so you
have it as reference
but i'm gonna explain that myself here
now if we go back to um where we had the
named route let's see
uh where did we have the name route when
we pushed it it was quite a bit before
this
if i can undo here
so this is something called an anonymous
route so sorry about that i said name
route but this is an anonymous route so
a route is as its name indicates in
flutter is it's a journey that has a
start and an end so it starts from a
view and it ends in a view okay that's a
route
um
however there are two types of routes
and you can create in flutter either you
do your routes either you go to a new
screen to your destination from the
current screen without providing any
sort of information about what this
route actually means to your application
so it's an anonymous route you're doing
it in line you're not telling flutter
about this route beforehand
so as the user presses the button or
for instance in this case as the user
ends up in the home page and the future
builder initializes firebase upon the
connections they've done meaning that
the initialization of firebase is
complete then we were pushing
the verify email view on the screen and
then we
fixed it by doing all this code
so that was an anonymous route you're
doing it in place as the done connection
state happens then we were pushing a new
route
uh in our navigator
but a named route is the exact same
thing that we write like we were doing
before but you tell flutter about that
route before so that when your
application is created and initialized
and the flutter engine starts it knows
that there is a route with the name xyz
for instance or fubar bass whatever you
want to define
and it goes to a certain
screen okay so that is the difference
between an anonymous route and a name
route in that as its name indicates a
named route
is a route that has a name so you tell
flutter that associate this particular
name as a type of string to this route
okay i'm going to take it here
in my notes that we've talked about that
so what we need to do now
is to define two routes for our
application one called slash login slash
and the other one is called slash
register
okay
so let me just go and ensure that i'm
bringing those routes correctly so
what i'm going to do here and you need
to do as well is to go to your main
function
and at the moment we have a title for a
material app and a theme data and then a
home here
but what you also have is a parameter
called routes okay so let's go and say
we want to create these routes
and you can see here it says routes its
value is a map of string and a builder
function for the values of those
uh string keys so it's a little bit
strange it's a map whose keys are
strings and
values are functions that take in a
build context sorry about that and
return a widget so it's a little bit of
a
it's like maybe a paradigm shift in your
head but these things do exist and i've
already i've also created my own classes
that kind of expect this kind of
parameter
so let's go into routes and say okay now
we have routes
as you know as you know this is how we
create a map map is a is a list of key
value pairs
or map entries as they're called in
flutter
and then what we need to do here is i'm
sorry but i'll just move some code
around i have three screens here so i
kind of have to manage those screens at
the same time i'm explaining things so
what we're gonna do here is to define
two routes slash login all right and
remember the value of this of the value
of every key inside this routes needs to
be a function you see it's a function
that returns a widget and it takes a
build context inside so in here what
we're going to do is say we have a
context
and we return actually sorry login slash
we return the login view all right so we
say have a route called slash login
slash and when that route is used it
returns the login view
an instance of the login view now we
need to do the exact same thing but for
register so i'm going to copy this
and here just going to say register and
instead return the register view which
we haven't imported into our main dart
file and you can remedy that by pressing
command dot on mac or control dot on
windows and linux and then say import
register
view
okay that's that and i'm gonna have a
look at my notes a little bit
so
what we need to do now um i've already
explained that okay in log area all
right so what we need to do now is to go
from login to the register view
and as you can see i've explained it
here in the caption that this will
actually cause an error but we will fix
this error as we go forward okay
so
in this uh register view here sorry in
this um
in our login view so let's go to the
login view we have this button right
here and what we need to do is just to
ensure that by pressing that we can go
to the correct place
and
i think i brought up the caption
and you can see that we need to use
navigator of context push named and
remove until
and this this is kind of a peculiar call
because what it essentially does is as
you can see right now on the screen we
have
the
login and
we basically the way we've created
things at the moment is that we have the
home view which is a widget
and then depending on the state of
actually no not depending on anything
we're literally just hard coding login
view to be returned inside this okay so
we have the home widget and then inside
this home widget we're inserting the
contents of login view so login view and
home page are kind of like displayed on
top of each other
and
this home page has the scaffold whereas
the
login view doesn't have any scaffold and
it's just a column at the moment if you
remember we can go back to login view so
you can see that it's just a column okay
so that's the structure currently by
doing this command that i'm providing
you here navigator of context push name
and remove until
what is going to happen is that as its
name indicates it's going to
remove everything
before it pushes this new route
so
is what we're basically saying here is
that by pressing the not registered yet
button and register here we're going to
nuke this screen remove it completely
from the screen and replace it by this
new widget that we're returning okay so
let's go to our login view in this
button here into the login view and
sorry in the not registered yet button
we say navigator of
context
and remove until here push and remove
until push named and remove until
and in here now we need to display our
register route and we refer to that
using its name
so
let's go and fix that now so we say here
slash register
and
put false there as it is and you can see
you can get documentation about this and
there's a predicate here that returns
returns true or false and it says push
the route with the given name onto the
navigator and then remove all the
previous routes until the predicate
returns true
and at the moment we're just saying
return false meaning return remove
everything from the route and just go to
the register view so just leave this as
false right now okay
and this is actually going to cause
a problem and you will see that soon i'm
going to hot restart just in case and we
go here to our login view
and i'm going to press the not
registered button here and boom and you
can see now um
that's actually great that we're getting
this error this is exactly what i what
i'd expected so
what is happening here is that we're
removing everything that's on the screen
and
pushing around to the screen that has no
scaffold so this is the problem that you
can see on the screen that yeah i can't
just display a column on the screen
without anything around it so we need
kind of a scaffold
and that is what this caption also is
saying at the bottom left of the screen
as i'm showing you here
i'll check some items in my um
screen
so as the next thing what we need to do
now is to go to our register view
which is what we're pushing here and
make sure that our register view now has
all of a sudden a scaffold all right so
let's go to
lib here and register view i'm gonna
remove this project explorer here at the
moment we're returning a column what i'm
gonna do is gonna command click on mac
or control click on linux and windows
and say wrap with
widget and then call this widget
scaffold
and just say scaffold body
and for the app bar create a new app bar
and for its title say text and this is
the register view or just say register
with constants okay we're just gonna
leave it like that i'm just gonna double
check in my notes to make sure that's
what i had intended for the register
view to actually be called yes i can see
that it was called register as well
there great
so
we have that now and you can see
now we're in the register view and there
is no error i'm gonna do a hot restart
and we go here again and now i'm gonna
press the not registered yet button and
you can see we are going to the register
view
okay
so now we have a good connection between
the login view to the register view
but there is no connection backwards
there's no connection from the register
view to the login view and that's
exactly what we're going to do now
just as we did um
i'm going to take some items in my notes
as well
so what just as we did in um
in the login view that i'm going to hot
restart so you just uh remember you can
be reminded of what we did we had a
login view as our login button and we
added a new item to go from login to
register but also we want to make sure
that if you are already registered and
you ended up on the screen then you can
go back to the login view okay so let's
do something similar here in our
register view
and
at the end of the register button here
let's create a new one and we say text
button
and uh on crest gonna get help from
visual studio code to create that
function signature and then i'm going to
say child
is a text that says
what should we say
already registered
log in here like this okay as a constant
and i comma here so we get the
formatting in place and now you can see
the register view also has a button that
says if you're already registered then
log in here and the login view has
not registered yet register here so
now we have to program this and as you
saw in the login view we had this
functionality navigator of push name
blah blah let's copy that functionality
from the login view and bring it into
the register view
under already registered button there
and instead of going to registered main
route we're going to go to the login
name route okay
and then
hot hot uh hot reload you don't have to
hot restart
i'm gonna press this button
and actually this is really great and
that's the
same point that i had here
so
uh link this okay
so i've talked about that i'm going to
just take some items um in the
in my notes to make sure that i've
covered all the grounds that i prepared
for
covering basically so you can see this
is the exact same error that we had in
the previous screen um
or in the previous situation that our uh
register view didn't have a scaffold
because we went from login view and to
register view and then register we
didn't have scaffolds so we created a
scaffold here
if you remember okay but if you go to
the login view you can see the login
view still returns a column and the way
i mean the reason this has been working
so far is that because our home page had
a scaffold do you remember here homepage
had a scaffold and the contents of login
view have have
so far just been injected into the body
of our home page and that's the reason
if you hot restart your application you
come to this beautiful home screen it
says home and then you have the login
view right here okay
so
what we need now is
if you remember from the previous
chapter we removed the scaffold from
their login and their register and now
we're putting them back but i kind of
want you to understand the reasoning
behind why i'm doing things i don't want
you to think that everything is perfect
from the beginning because for me at
least when things are done perfectly in
the beginning i always question like
what if this thing wasn't there and i'm
just trying to make sure that we remedy
these things so you go through the
entire journey you see what's wrong and
how we can fix it instead of just
me presenting to you the exact right way
of doing things so
from the beginning
let's go to our login view and make sure
we do the same thing that we did with
register view and
add a scaffold
so let's go in here and add a scaffold
so i'm going to write i'm going to click
on it sorry i'm going to command
and we're going to press command and dot
on it on mac or control dot on linux and
windows and you say wrap with widget and
just say your widget is called scaffold
scaffold unfortunately doesn't have a
child parameter so it has a body
so change that parameter to body
and let's create an app bar for it then
we say app bar
and it has a title and we say const text
and in here we just say login
okay
all right now
as you can see i mean we've now added
the scaffold and as the top as the
caption here is telling you it says
about login view is being embedded into
home page this isn't good
so now what we need to do is to go to
the next uh
section which is we need to remove now
the scaffold from our main dart or from
the home page because
for
right now home page is our login view is
being embedded into home page but that
isn't really good enough
so
we can't have login view with its own
scaffold being embedded inside a home
page that already has a scaffold so
uh what we need to do is to remove the
scaffold from our homepage uh let's see
if we can do that and it doesn't seem
like it's working so i'm gonna go
and
say that i'm gonna grab the future
builder okay and this is what you need
to also do
grab the entire future builder and
instead of returning the scaffold just
return your future builder just like i'm
doing here
all right um
[Music]
there's a lot of information and also
let's make sure that our um
verify email view also has a scaffold
because this is what we need right now
we need all our views to have a scaffold
so i'm going to
embed our verify email views columns as
well inside a scaffold
so
wrap with widget and let's say scaffold
there is no child in
scaffold remember there is a body and
then we say app bar is an app bar a
title effect const
text and we say verify email something
like this okay
good now if i command s in order to save
all these changes we're gonna get an
error
hopefully
which we didn't and that's also okay
it's probably because we actually fixed
home page so it doesn't have a scaffold
that's why we're not getting the error
so
that is really good i've also explained
that then
so let's just make sure that the
connection is working between these two
screens so
login view is there you can see there is
no home page any anymore displayed here
if you remember from before this
refactoring then when we sh when we
showed the login view then there was the
home pages app bar displayed on the
screen but home page right now is just a
future builder that returns other things
such as a text of loading or the login
view
and also here i noticed that instead of
logging loading what we could do is to
display a circular progress indicator
this is a great widget if you're if
you're just doing some sort of a loading
that may not immediately have an end so
what circular progress indicator does it
just shows like a loading indicator we
could actually comment all of this code
out and just return the circular
progress indicator and comment the
switch out as well and then press
command s so you actually see how it
looks like it's ginormous at the moment
because there's no scaffold around it
but if you had scaffold everything put
in place then you would see the circle
progress indicator actually displayed
correctly on the screen so
let's go back
command s so we see the log loadings
sorry the login screen or the login view
and the connection between those screens
is working as
well the next thing we need to do is to
at the moment you see we have our login
view and the register view so they're in
their own files but in the main guard
file we've kind of forgotten or maybe
not forgotten we just haven't had the
time to do that we have the verify email
view still rightly like it's just
displayed or it's coded in the main dart
file so what we need to do is just to
create an an own file for it and we call
it verify email view okay so go to views
here and right click on it new file and
say
verify
email view dot dart okay
and grab the code from verify email view
here
and paste it
or cut it basically and just place it
here
and make sure all the imports are in
place i've already explained in previous
chapters how we need to fix imports
so i'm not going to go into so much
detail about how imports work and how we
should do that because i think if you've
already gone through the chapters
chronologically then this is like
obvious for you how to fix it so it kind
of feels like if i try to over explain
all these things over and over again the
people who are watching this course
chronologically from the beginning and
they're kind of gonna get bored so in
the interest of not boring actual people
who are watching things i'm not gonna
over explain so there we go that is
fixed and also let's make sure that we
import firebase off as well so that
error goes away
save just
make sure that hot
we do a hot restart as well just make
sure everything is working as expected
and it does
so what we need to do now also in
in the interest of
uh
following through with the plan of
being a good software developer
what we talked about not in the previous
chapter but i think it was in chapter
let's see it was in chapter 15 i believe
where we talked about git and github now
we've done a lot of code things are
working great let's commit our code okay
so as we had if i bring up the terminal
here i'm going to do this so you see a
little bit better i'm going to bring up
terminal
and let's go to our terminal here i can
see scrcpy is running in this terminal
so i'm going to create a new terminal
here
and i'm going to just say be it log and
you can see we had the initial commit
and that was step one all right so
because we tagged it as a step one you
see here so what we do let's just get
git status and we see that we've done a
lot of work i'm gonna get add all the
files to the staging area remember from
the git chapter
and then let me also make this a little
bit bigger so you can see it better
um
okay then i'm gonna commit and i'm gonna
say git commit step two like this
okay um
and also actually before we do that i
believe we've missed a few things
then i just look a little bit in my
notes just to make sure that i'm not
missing things before we continue
if i look at um
yeah so what we need to actually there's
one thing we missed here at the moment
what we're doing is saying that okay
just go to the login view but one thing
that we've missed is to ensure that we
go to the correct correct view okay so
what we're gonna do is
we say we first get the current user so
we say here's the user
and
if the user is not
null
here
and we put an else statement here as
well
so
if the user is not null then we
say okay
um if user
email verified
so
and we just say print email is verified
or we just return
text
email is verified something like this
okay
let's go back to the print so
before we actually do all this maybe i
should explain why we're doing this so
at the moment or before we started with
this exercise right here
whenever the application was running we
were just going directly to the login
screen but what we need to do now is to
now that we have three screens we have
the login view register view and also
the verify email view
is that what we call it verify email
view yeah
we need to make sure that we're actually
accommodating these various conditions
into returning the the correct widget so
here we're saying that if the user's
email is verified
let's then say just say
email is verified okay
and we can actually return maybe even a
um
and we'll return something so yeah let's
do that so we will return text
done something like that okay
if the email is verified we just say
that your email is verified but the user
doesn't see that if the email is not
verified we will we will basically
return
verify email view okay so
that's us basically saying that yeah you
need to verify your email
that's if user is not null
now
if the user is null then we send you to
the login view so let's go in here in
the ill statement we say return login
view
as a constant
so i think
that should do it to be honest with you
return cons return log so we can remove
all of this from here
boom
so let's review it
upon firebase initialization being done
successfully we are going to
check for the current user if there is a
user we're gonna check if the email is
verified if email is verified right now
we're just going to say print email is
verified and since we're not returning
anything in here the code is going to
fall through to line 48 here which in
turn then returns just a text done okay
so if you have a logged in user sorry if
you have a user who's
logging into the application and the
email is verified all the user is going
to see is just a text done all right
but if you have a user in the
application whose email is not verified
that user is going to see the verify
email view
if you don't have a user with firebase
so that user is not logged in then we're
going to display the login view all
right
a lot of information i understand this
may be a little bit frustrating so
so now i'm going to hot restart and what
you can see here is just a very ugly
text done displayed on the screen this
means the current user in the
application is logged in and the email
is verified and
it is very ugly i understand but you
need to also understand the reason why
this is ugly at the moment and that is
what happens if you do not tell flutter
how things need to be rendered and
since our home page has a future builder
and nothing else surrounding it there is
no scaffold there's nothing it's just a
text widget that's flutter telling you
okay i don't even know how to render
things anymore i don't know what theme
you're using i don't know the font size
i don't know the default font color so
that's what happens if you don't
surround your widgets with a scaffold or
another
material widget that knows how to render
things okay
wow a lot of information again um but i
hope you're sticking with me here
now that we've done that we can go and
commit so let's have it look at our logs
and look at the status i'm gonna change
the structure or the layout of the
screen so you see better
and now now we see that after we did git
add we've also changed the main dart
file with these changes so i'm gonna get
at that as well all those changes and
i'm gonna say git commit step two okay
so now that's gonna be committed and
we're also going to push the commit
and additionally we need to tag it okay
because if you remember if you look at
the logs
the first commit that we did here it was
tagged as
step one
now we've committed step two but we
haven't tagged it so let's go tag it
i'm gonna say git tag
um step two
and then you need to push your tags with
bit push
dash dash
tags and that creates the step two tag
as well for you okay
i understand that was a lot of
information but i hope you could stick
with me and go through all these steps
so that we are ready basically for the
next chapter
all right and also before continuing
with the next chapter just ensure that
you're logged in because in the next
chapter we're actually going to work on
the log out so
i can see also i've planned a lot of
information in that chapter for you so
there's lots and lots and lots of things
to do
so it's a very exciting chapter actually
the next chapter and but before you
continue with that just ensure that you
go to the login screen and ensure that
you log in with the user and you just
see this ugly done button here okay
and
as i mentioned in the next chapter we're
going to talk about displaying a simple
interface to the users who are logged in
and also allow those logged in users to
log out so
get some coffee tea if you want to or
whatever refreshments you want and i'll
see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 18 of this
flutter course
in previous chapters we've talked a lot
about login and
registration views
and and we've also talked about
integration with firebase
we now have pretty much like our login
and register view
well i don't want to say we've got them
down but
we have a basic login and a basic
registration view
um
if you remember from the previous
chapter we kind of left the application
and state that
if the application detected that you
had um
you were a logged in user and that you
had a verified email address then we
showed kind of like a
dirty done text on the screen and i can
bring bring the screen up on my android
phone here
and you see we kind of left it in this
state
and i'll bring the code up as well so
you just get
reminded of what we were doing so we
left the application in this state that
if the user wasn't null meaning that the
user was present and that
his or her email address was actually
verified we simply did a print statement
in there and
we left it like that meaning that
since our builder function
of
let me actually bring up the right
caption as well
since the builder function of the future
builder requires that you return a
widget by moving your mouse over you can
actually see that it says required
widget you need to return a widget from
that function
since it requires that what we did is
just we put a like a return cons text at
the end of all our if statements so if
none of these were present there we're
still returning a text okay
and since that was there and in this
user email verified we're not returning
a widget
then the code falls through to this line
meaning that if you're a logged in user
and you're verified then we're returning
the text off done
so we need to kind of um now start
because you see okay before i say that
sentence
now that we
are have handled the email verification
view so if you're if you're a logged in
user but your email isn't verified we
displayed it verify email and if you're
if you aren't
registered meaning that like you don't
have a user then we show the login view
since we've got those down what we need
to do now is to work on the actual main
ui of our application because what you
can see here that says done this should
be the main ui of our application so
users who are logged in and their emails
are ready are verified should see the
main ui of the application so
in this chapter we're actually going to
work on the main ui of our application
and then allow the user to log out from
our application as well so i'm just
looking at my notes to ensure i'm
telling you all the stuff that i plan to
tell you
so without further ado maybe we could
actually get started with that so let's
go into our
main dart file here and create a new
widget
so
i'm going to bring it up here
and we're
going to create a new stateful widget
called notes view
and this notes you just imagine that it
is the
it is the main ui of the application for
people who are
logged in okay so as i mentioned before
stf to create a stateful widget and then
we call it um
notes
view i believe all right
now what we need to do
let's see it doesn't even really have a
scaffold or anything so maybe that's
what we need to do i'm just gonna
go here
so let's go create a scaffold and an app
bar for it all right
so
we go in here into where we're returning
a container at the moment we just say we
want a scaffold
and for our scaffold we want an app bar
and the app bar should just be an app
bar
with a title of um const
text
and we just say
what should we call it i don't think
i've got notes for that to be honest
with you let's just call it your notes
or something like that
i'm gonna actually go and have a look at
my notes to see
what i've called it in that
um
where i was actually preparing this
course for you and i can see i've
written main ui so let's just do that
let's just say main ui in here okay so
we have a scaffold in there
so and
it just says main ui and the
body is empty at the moment so there is
nobody and if you remember from previous
chapters when you return a scaffold and
an app bar all it does is that it
creates kind of like depending on your
theme but usually with the light theme
it creates a a bluish status bar and an
app bar with white text for the app bars
title
and the rest of the content of the
screen is just going to be white so it's
kind of like an empty container kind of
okay
now we have that in place
and we are going to
go to our uh
future builder here in our home page
and instead of doing this
returning text done
we're going to remove that and now we're
going to get an error saying that well
the case should not complete normally
try adding break or return and that's
basically it's complaining in this
line of code here for me in line 41 it
may be another line of code for you
so it's saying that well one of the
cases of your your like the entire block
of code that you're placing in here it
doesn't always end with a return and
that's exactly right because in the case
of user being email verified we're not
returning a widget and what we're going
to do in here we're just going to say
return const
to you okay
all right um and i'm going to press
command s there and now we did a hot uh
reload and you can see the main ui of
the application
and in my notes i can see here that
we're going to go and place a little
text in
our scaffold here
and for your
app bar
we're good to go for the body let's just
say const text
hello world okay
so now we can see the hello world
displayed right there
i can see i have a lot of notes to be
honest with you with this chapter so i'm
really making sure that i'm looking at
my notes while i'm giving you the
content to ensure that you're getting
all the information that i plan for you
to get so i apologize if i'm looking a
lot at my notes it's just to
yeah it's just to deliver the best
content for you to be honest
okay so we've done that hello world
now
what we need to talk about is um
the app bar class and i've provided a
link here for you
which i'm going to
open on my screen and then bring to this
screen so you can also see it
increase the size a little bit and
perhaps also do this layout so you can
see it's um the caption as well
so
you can see for appbar the documentation
just says a material design app bar an
app bar consists of a toolbar and
potentially other widgets so
all you need to do really or all you
need to know about an app bar is
that um
it it
it is able to display
various widgets i mean pretty much
everything in flutter is a widget so an
app bar isn't an exception
and an app bar consists of various
components
the default app bar allows you to
display a title as you can see here in
the title by default has its own styling
it means that it has its own left and
top and
bottom margins so by default it's like
displayed vertically in the middle of
your app bar as you can see in the main
ui of our application so
pretty much every
material component pretty much
everything you display on the screen has
a theme
okay and
an app bar has its own theme and it has
its own capabilities
so what we're going to do the where
we're going to use the app bar in the
main ui of our application
is not only to display a title but it's
also to display
a um a little button
to the far right that the user can click
on or tap on
in in our case tap on because there'll
be indirect users are going to run our
application on mobile devices so they're
going to tap and if we allowed the
our application to be run on desktops
then they'd be able to click and maybe
even tap on if they're running for for
instance um
microsoft's
what is it called surface book or
surface
lap
tablets
so
this is what an app bar is as is like
the gist of it and there's information
here in the documentation you can see
here it says there's a leading space and
then there's or you can actually put a
widget in the leading and then there's a
title and then some other actions and
these are the things we're actually
going to use actions in this um
in this section in this chapter of our
uh
flutter course so you can see here for
instance there's actually
code on how to configure an app bar with
some button you can see you can press
the button and then you get a snack bar
right here
okay so keep this in mind you can have a
look at the documentation i really
actually suggest that you do that
and um
and you can you can spend some time
reading through the documentation but i
don't think you need to get absorbed in
the documentation so much but just have
a look at the various parts of an app
bar and try it for yourself okay
so
um
i can see that i've told you about the
documentaries i'm gonna um
i'm gonna move past that
so that that part is done um
and now what i think we need to do
um is to talk about uh this print
statement and why we were getting an
error here
you see print
if if i if i put a print here and if i
say print hello world
you usually get
information here saying avoid print
calls in production code okay
so
before we move past this because you've
probably seen this quite a lot in this
course that i've placed print statements
and then we can like for instance if i
bring up the debug console and just do
command s on my mac or control so linux
and windows in order to hot reload
you'll see
let's see actually email verify heart
reload i'll restart here
oops see i can see that it crashed
that's okay so i'm gonna go and bring up
scr cpy again
and these things do happen and that's
completely fine so and i'm gonna need to
run the application again because i
actually lost my connection with that
device but while that is doing its job
i'm gonna tell you also about
print
and versus a log you see
uh
print is usually called a poor man's
debugger in that um if you're not a
software developer you probably don't
know about even debugging what that
means but what debugging is is it
essentially is is where there is a
problem in your source code but you
don't know really where so you try to
step through various lines of code in
your application and refine what the
problem is
so
um a lot of a lot of times when people
don't really either they don't have the
time to debug or they believe that the
debugger is just too slow they start
putting print statements in their
application and
um by putting print statements in their
application they can kind of track where
they where the application is going
through the various lines of code and if
for instance they put a print statement
in a place of code where they didn't
expect the application to end up and
then they'd be like oh okay i ended up
in this code block i shouldn't have so
let me just check why i ended up here so
it's kind of called a poor amount
debugging because print is a piece of
code that you actually place in your
code so sometimes print isn't the
desirable thing to do
in banking applications for instance you
should be extremely careful what you
print because these things get logged
and you you may think well okay they get
logged on that phone uh what is the
problem with that
the problem with logging things even if
it's on the phone is that you you must
know that the operating systems android
and ios usually like the most popular
ones right now they keep track of your
lot so these logs are actually stored in
a place on the operating system so you
can actually read them back later so
there is a buffer so this information
that your application may be printing to
the console isn't completely private
except that it is stored on the phone
even if it's for a short while while it
gets replaced by a new buffer if your
phone ends up in the wrong hands someone
can actually get a hold of your lock so
imagine a banking application logs your
like a login information username
password all that detail and even if
it's only for that application you may
think but someone else it may actually
end up in the wrong hand so that's what
this information is telling you avoid
print calls in production code okay so
there is another way of doing this
um
instead of doing prints you can actually
use log
in your in your code and we're gonna i
believe
we're actually going to talk about in
this chapter
i think we're gonna talk about logging
so let me have a look here in my
notes um yes we're actually going to
talk about logging instead of printing
so
just keep that in mind that there's a
better way of doing print statements if
if they're if that's what you want to do
if that's what you want to see
on the console so we're gonna fix that
soon and this is you see hello world
information that was printed by this
print statement okay so sorry about that
that was just a little detour but i i
thought it was necessary to tell you
especially if you haven't done software
development before
okay we've done the return notes view in
the home page we shouldn't have any
print in the home page and you can see
this is our home page right now and we
don't have any print statements let me
change the
view a little bit all right
so um
so what i'm gonna now describe to you is
that we need a an enumeration that
describes our various um
app bar
items that the user can click on you see
when we create our app bar
and this app bar will in itself be able
to
display something called a pop-up all
right so i haven't shown you how this is
going to work by the end of this chapter
so it may be a little bit difficult to
understand but just imagine that we have
our ui here and what we need to achieve
in this chapter is to place a little
button here with like a dot dot either
horizontally or vertically i don't
really know what the icon is going to be
so some sort of a button here upon
pressing which
the user will get a little fine nice
like a drop down and in this drop down
then you can place various items like
log out
settings blah blah blah so imagine we
have a drop down by pressing that button
and upon pressing the log out button
then we're going to display a dialect to
the user saying are you sure you want to
log out from the application so
this works very nicely i mean when
before i say this works very nicely
maybe i should explain that by pressing
each one of these items in the pop-up
menu that we're going to display to the
user we are going to get a call back
from the system saying oh this item got
pressed
and you need to tell the system what
this item is you can either give it like
an integer like a
numerical value or a string or even
better better you can give it an
enumeration value if you remember from
the
chapters where we talked about dart
basics we talked about enumerations and
why they're important and and that they
make things very easy because when you
specifying your enumeration and put
cases in your animation
and then
you you let me actually change this to
also do not do so sorry about i just
remember that
and you give those innovation values to
your pop-up menu items by press but by
the user pressing on any of those items
you will then get that enumeration value
back so you can do a switch statement in
your a callback and say oh which item
got called was it this case of the
enumeration so instead of you doing like
integer comparisons or string
comparisons you can actually use
enumerations which make your life a lot
easier
so
we are going to talk about that
soon as you can see an enumeration that
describes our pop-up and we're going to
work on that soon
okay
we talked about that um
all right so
now let's talk about pop-up menu button
versus pop-up menu item
and as you can see the caption says
they're usually used together and let's
go actually bring up safari here and i'm
going to say pop-up menu item flutter
and i'm going to bring up the document
documentation up here okay
so we can have a look at it together
as you can see it says an item in a
material design pop-up menu so this is
the actual menu item itself so if you
imagine we're displaying a drop down
menu every item in that pop-up menu item
is of type sorry
every item in the pop-up menu
is of type pop-up menu item all right
and you can see a pop-up menu item in
itself has
a i mean a pop-up menu item is a generic
in advanced um a dart chapter we also
talked about generics and what a generic
item in this case a pop-up menu item
basically is
is that it has a value of this type that
it says
is off in this case a pop-up menu item
is
why farther is a pop-up menu item is of
type y farther now we don't really know
why if either
why farther is but it could just be an
enumeration okay and you can see here
now
after you've decided decided that a
pop-up menu item
carries a value of of this type then its
value should actually be specified and i
can see that there is a case called
harder
in that animation that you've assigned
to your pop-up menu item okay
now
what is a pop-up menu button so let's
search here pop-up menu button okay
let's go into the documentation here and
you can see it says displays a menu when
pressed and calls unselected when the
menu is dismissed all right so
um
what you need to know is that the pop-up
menu button is the actual
button that we will place on kind of on
our app bar upon pres upon pressing
which it will display
a menu and you can see here in the code
you see here
the pop-up menu button
has an unselected callback and it has an
item builder
and items inside the pop-up menu item
then are
sorry the items inside the pop-up menu
button
are of type pop-up menu item so
imagine then you have the pop-up menu
button as like the parent
and then you will have its item builder
and each of which of these items are of
type pop-up menu item and that's exactly
what we're actually gonna do
in this chapter
okay i'm gonna close that window i don't
think we need the safari window here um
so
now i think i explained this part of the
caption a little bit just now about when
we talked about the pop-up menu item but
you can see here i've said pop-up menu
item has a value let's look at the code
for pop-up menu items so maybe we could
just actually right here pop-up menu
item in our code and i'm going to
command click on it and you can also see
that a pop-up menu item has this
property called value okay and as you
can see a pop-up menu item as i
mentioned before is a generic class that
carries a value of type t and type d
basically when you see t in generics it
just means something that you specified
so anything that's specified inside the
less than and greater than size is a
generic name
which then gets replaced at a compile
time with the type that you as a
programmer specify okay
so
um that's the code for the pop-up menu
item and you're more than welcome to
drill down more into into that code to
understand it better
so
let's then go and create uh
our enumeration that we've now talked
about
and
i'm just going to go in
here right above the notes view
and let's then define an enumeration
called menu action and in there we're
gonna have a case called log out okay so
let's say enum
menu action we said we're gonna call it
and then we have a case called log out
in there so if i do command s to hover
reload then nothing happens and the dart
formatter i can actually see they form
our code very well for us
so the next part that we need to take
care of
is to actually display our pop-up menu
button you can see in notes app view
state app bar create a pop-up menu
button of type menu action
so
in the app bar in order for us to be
able to display a little action there we
need to um
actually go to the app bar here
and you can see there is a property
called actions which is it says it's a
list of widgets all right so we're gonna
say we need actions there okay i'm also
just going to ensure that i have
everything here so i can see the code as
well and my notes
i can take in my notes that we've talked
about things
like the menu
action
um
all right and now we're gonna create the
pop-up menu button all right so
you see the action as we saw in the
source code on the website that i
displayed you and that i displayed to
you as the documentation inside the
actions of our app bar then we're going
to create items of type pop-up menu
button okay so let's go ahead and do
that
pop-up menu button
all right and then you can see it has an
item builder okay
and and
i think it's actually an item builder
and also unselected so
let's first actually take care of the
unselected so i'm going to put
unselected command space in visual
studio code on a mac and control space
in linux and windows in order to get
this dialog get some help from visual
studio code to complete this code for us
you see upon selected it's going to
return the value to us and we're telling
darth in here that our pop-up menu
button actually manages values of type
menu action all right which is what we
specified right here okay
and you can see we're getting an error
saying that the named parameter item
builder is required okay and we'll
provide that now
so let's go and create a
item builder here
get help from visual studio code with
the same command that i mentioned to you
before
and in here then we're going to create a
constant of a pop-up menu item
and we're going to say that this menu
item actually manages
values of type menu action as well okay
and we're going to say according to the
documentation remember every pop-up menu
item has a value so a value associated
with it which then in turn gets passed
to this unselected function
when this pop-up menu item is tapped
okay so then we're going to say in this
case it has the value of menu actions
when you actually log out
and this child is just going to be
a text
that says
log out
okay and as a const as well actually the
entire thing is a cons so we don't have
to do that okay
so we just uh let me have a look item
builder
menu actions constant body might return
normally okay
okay i see because the item builder if
we move our mouse over it
if i move the mouse over item blue you
can actually see that it needs a list of
pop-up menu entry
and you can see pop-up menu item if you
go to this code is actually of type
pop-up menu entry so the problem we're
seeing here is that it says you aren't
returning a list but you're just
returning an item so we're going to say
return a list
and in here we just say
turn that item okay
like that
can we actually make that entire list
const so yeah that works as well okay
i'm gonna do command s and what you'll
see here now is
uh we've actually added log out
um
so and you'll see here now by pressing
this then we'll get a beautiful pop-up
menu
here
and there is a log out item in it all
right
so
that logout text there is the child of
our pop-up menu item so
don't worry i mean don't get confused
with the child and the value what you
need to know is that the child is what
the user sees and the value is what you
as a programmer see because
when the user then taps on that item
your unselected is going to get called
and then we'll get that value so just to
test that let's go back to our print
statement and say value
and i'm going to bring up the console
here going to clear it and i'm gonna
change the ui layout a little bit so you
see it better i'm gonna do command s and
then i'm gonna tap on this log out
button poof
you'll see now our unselected got called
and the out value
which was what you associated with your
pop-up menu item
got printed here and got sent sent to
the unselected
okay so we've done that part we've
handled it with double quotes we haven't
really handled but we're just printing
its value right now okay
so i'm just gonna
go through some of the things that i
plan to
talk to you about um
uh
okay
all right so
we can see that the print statement is
um doing its job so
in the previous part of this chapter i
talked about why print usually isn't a
good idea and
there is a better way of doing print and
that is with logging so
dart itself comes
pre-packed with a package called
developer
and you can easily import developer and
inside the developer tools for dart
there is a good function called log and
you can use log which is a more
trustworthy and more even configurable
version of print and i'm going to show
you how to do that
so in your import statements let me
increase the size of the screen a little
bit so you see it better
say import dart from dart import
developer okay
now i haven't talked so much about
import statements before but import is
actually configurable as well so in here
for instance if you look at the code
inside import this dart developer
there's a lot of stuff that you might
not need in your application okay so by
importing
um a package or a library in your
program you're pretty much importing
everything that that package also
imports so in this case extension
profile or service timeline
and these things then get
these things will then be available in
your workspace just by you pressing for
instance for me is control space on my
macintosh so all these symbols will then
be available right here so there's tons
and tons of things that are available
right now in your application without
you having to do anything just because
you imported quite a lot of things now
by importing the dart developer
package in this case also you're making
all those symbols available kind of like
globally inside this file at least and
some developers don't like that some
developers kind of like to limit the
amount of symbols available
and only have the symbols available that
they actually work with okay
and because of this there is a good
functionality for import and dart where
you can say show
and by doing a show you are telling dart
that um
you only want to import a specific part
of this package so the specific part
that you're interested in is a function
called log
now
after doing this you can basically go to
your application and then say log
now a lot of developers also don't like
this because they think oh log where did
that come from so
um if you want to be more specific where
functions come from especially if
they're not your own functions or maybe
even if you have few log functions maybe
you even have a log function in in this
code right here like if you say void log
um like this
and then you type log here
i mean it's there are so many logs
available now i don't even know which
one is which so
what
dart allows you to do is to give an
alias to your import so for instance if
you want to use the log function that is
provided in this developer package for
you you can actually give an alias to
this entire package in this source file
which is the main dart file so you can
say as
i'm going to say dev tools okay so what
happens here is that the log function
now is not available as it was before
except you have to say devtools log and
then you'll see that there's a log
function and that's the only function
available inside devtools now because it
says show
if you hadn't done the show here
then devtools will have everything that
dev tools or the developer package in
this case uh allowed you to
or import it into your workspace okay so
do the code then as this import devtools
show log and the reason i'm explaining
all of these is because i think these
are so important to understand
and that
you need to get them like
as soon as possible and now that i'm
explaining these things in such detail
i'm not going to explain them anywhere
else in inside this chapter so i don't
want to have like half explained
things
that we actually need to fully
understand and explain half of it now
and then half of it later because then
you may not be able to
chain the information to get the entire
picture so that's why i'm explaining
things sometimes in such great detail
okay now that we've done as devtools
show log let's go to this print
statement that we put here
in our notes in the unselected and then
say dev tools
log okay
and you can see now that it's
complaining to us because it says the
devtools log it doesn't allow us to
print a value and if you have a look at
the log fi and log function signature it
expects a message of type string but our
a menu action is an enumeration but you
can always say to string on an
enumeration value in order to make it a
string so
um so what we're going to do then is to
go and
click on this log out and now you see a
log item being printed to the screen and
it's a little bit more distinct as well
you can see now now that we're not using
print using log make sure that your log
items are a little bit more
distinguished inside the debug console
so that's also a good plus
all right
let's go now to the next item
so what we're gonna do here now we have
the log out
button here so i'm going to tap on it it
says log out we have that
already present
what we need to do now is upon pressing
this item we are going to display a
little dialogue to the user
now if you're a designer you may be
familiar with a dialogue and the
dialogue is basically like an alert
displayed on the screen depending on
what type of operating system you're
running on but both android and ios and
ipad os mac os windows everything they
have their own
way of handling dialogues and dialogues
are usually like a small little window
displayed usually in the center of the
main screen where that application is
placed and the dialogues are
configurable usually with a title with
the description text or even images and
usually with some action buttons which
are called cta or call to action
so
that is the exact same case here in
flutter so upon pressing this log out
button we're going to display a dialogue
to the user saying oh you want we see
that you want to log out are you sure
you want to log out and then like a
cancel or no button and a yes button
which is the call to action or cta okay
so um
what we need to do now is to create that
function a function that can display an
alert dialog
to the user and you can see here that in
the caption i've mentioned write a login
function to display a dialog
and its
signature is kind of like it returns a
feature of boolean and if you think i
mean if you really think about it a
dialogue that asks the user to log out
either has a cancel or a null button or
sorry it has
either a cancel or no button and
a
a call to action which does the log out
so it either logs out or it doesn't
or basically it either confirms that you
need to be logged out or it says no you
shouldn't be like that so it's true
false okay so a boolean so boolean is
perfect for this case
um and what we're going to do now is to
write a function that returns a future
of that boolean saying true you have to
be logged out or false not and we're
going to call it show logout dialog okay
so let's go at the bottom of this file
and
and say future and
bull
and as i've mentioned in the caching
we're going to call the show log out
dialog and we say build context because
we need actually context to display our
log out
button on
okay a lot of information now um i'm
gonna go actually a little bit back to
the previous caption
uh because i forgot to mention something
there um
and the important thing to mention here
are two things called show dialogue and
alert dialogue now show dialog
actually let's go to alert dialog first
alert dialog we can see is a class is a
stateless widget which defines the the
dialog that gets displayed to the user
itself so it doesn't have any concept of
being displayed to the screen or
what happens when the dialogue is
created after that point it doesn't care
about that so it just
performs the action of creating an alert
dialogue for you
that's for alert dialogue but
you need a way to display that alert
dialogue to the user and the way to do
that is with show
i believe it's called show dialogue
and
you can see here show dialog is a
function that returns an optional future
or sorry a future of an optional value
there's a difference between an optional
future and a future of an optional value
so in this case it's a future that
always gets returned but it optionally
contains a value okay and you can see it
says okay give me a context and then you
have to provide a builder to me okay and
this builder should return a widget so
what we're gonna say is going to say
show the dialogue you can see here
and and
and builder we're going to get help from
visual studio code to complete it all
right
and in here in our builder what we're
going to do is we're going to actually
create our alert dialog okay
so uh
let's go back to this caption so we know
what we're doing what what the actual
goal is here okay
so in
the builder you're responsibility is to
create an alert dialogue so let's say we
return
an alert dialog which is a widget as you
saw before
and it has a title you can see the title
is a widget
actually right like here is a widget
for the title we're going to create a
const of text and
the text i can see we set sign out here
so we're basically configuring the alert
dialog okay
right now the title
then for the contents
or the content also is a widget and
we're going to say this is also a const
text and we're going to ask the user
are you sure you want to sign out okay
just like that
now that we've put the title and the
content in there we need to specify the
parameters call actions and you can see
the type of this actions is list of
widgets all right and this is like the
buttons that the user will see on this
alert dialog
what we're going to do is going to
create two text buttons so i'm going to
say text button all right
and don't worry about all these errors
and things that we're seeing here this
is because as i mentioned in one of the
previous chapters or one of the first
introduction chapters i think
is because we have an extension here
called error lens and aero lens is
extend expanding all these errors that
are happening as we type and it's
displaying it on the screen it looks
really scary it looks like we're doing
everything wrong but these these bro
these errors actually do make sense if
you look at it it says text button the
named parameter on press is required but
there's no corresponding blah blah so we
need to fix these things okay so let's
go to text button and say unpressed get
help from visual studio go to complete
it and then after that i'm pressing say
child
so this first button is actually gonna
be our cancel button okay
so that's the first text button and copy
this text button now and paste it in
here and instead of cancel this time say
log out all right and
like that now you see there's a lot less
information displayed on the screen and
it looks a lot better okay
so
now we have an alert with two buttons
cancel log out but you can see upon
pressing those buttons we aren't doing
anything here okay and we need to fix
this actually so let's go ahead and
first say we are returning this show
dialog which returns the value of
boolean and now you see we get a general
error here saying that wait you said
you're returning a future of bull but
this show dialogue of bull is going to
return an optional so what what do you
mean so this is dark getting a little
bit confused
quite correctly actually is saying that
you saying that you return a boolean but
we know that show a dialogue returns an
optional boolean so what do you want to
do about it and a way to fix this to be
honest with you is
you
append something called a then function
to the entire show dialogue saying that
okay
if this show dialogue isn't able to
return a boolean then i'm going to
return false otherwise return the value
of the show dialogue so
um
because i mean you may be now asking why
wouldn't the show dialogue return a
value it either has a cancel or a logout
button but remember on android for
instance you have these physical keys
i'm going to change the layout so you
see this button down here if i show a
dialogue on the screen android users can
always press this little button which
will then change to an arrow down that
they can press on it to dismiss the
dialogue so they they have the ability
to dismiss a dialogue without actually
answering a question that the dialogue
asks them and ios users can sometimes
also tap outside a dialogue in order to
cancel that dialogue so that is why show
dialogue says i may not be able to
return
the value that i promised kind of to
return should this or tap on any of my
buttons quite correctly okay so append a
then statement let me change the screen
layout here
so append event statement here which is
a function that gets called
should this future complete so if the
user dismisses this dialogue this future
is going to complete but it won't have a
value you see it is an optional bull in
that case so in here we say either you
return a value
if it's present or you return false
that's it okay now you see dart is quite
happy about this all right
now what we need to also do is
you see the way we're gonna
the way we're gonna display this
dialogue is to
tell flutter that
hey
this like pause everything you're doing
and display this dialogue modelly on the
screen
and this dialog is going to grab focus
from everything else that's on the
screen so the user kind of has to go and
choose an item unless they want to
cancel that item by for instance
pressing the
physical key on an android phone
now
when we display the dialog we're going
to use the build contents context and
the navigator
and display the screen just like we
display like a named route so
the show dialogue function here inside
our text buttons on press it is our
responsibility as the alert dialogue to
to dismiss ourselves
and it's our responsibility to actually
pass a value to this show dialogue and
say hey this button was pressed and this
is the value that it returned
so
what you to do on these unpressed is to
say navigator
of
context and then you'll say pop
and then you
provide your value the boolean value in
this case so upon cancelling we'll pop
with the value of false
and we copy this code and we go into the
on press of the second text button which
is log out and in this case we should we
say that you should basically return
true
all right
that was a lot of code i understand that
let's just make sure formatting is
correct as well put commas here before
your parentheses end so the formatting
is a little bit nicer in that case
so
that's our
show log out dialog
function
now as the caption says what we need to
do is to go and display this
dialogue to the user
and the way to do that is
upon
the user tapping this log out button
here you see the value is a menu action
so what we're going to do
is going to um do a switch statement so
we say switch
value
and what i really like about
uh the
this
warning that we're getting here saying
the missing cause clause for log out
dart is already understanding that
um
there's a case statement and there's a
case in this menu action enumeration
that we're not handling and it's asking
us to do that so you could tap on this
little
here icon and say add missing case
clauses or you can say command dot on
mac or control dot on linux and windows
to bring up this menu also and i've also
understood from my conversations with
others on linkedin that this option is
also available on vim
and other editors because this is part
of the language front end actually so
it's not only a thing you can do in
visual studio code thankfully
so
go and add the missing case clauses
and in this case what we need to do now
is to display our alert so we're going
to say await should log out or something
and we say sorry final
should log out is equal to wait and now
we're going to call this function that
we created show logout dialog
okay
and now it's complaining saying that you
can't do wait because this function here
is unselected is not asynchronous so now
we're gonna make it asynchronous and
then we're gonna say devtools
log
should log out to a string okay
so command s and let's go to our ui now
and i'm going because we're doing
devtools log i'm going to bring up the
debug console here clear it so you see
better and i'm going to press the log
out now you see our dialogue is
displayed to the user saying sign up are
you sure you want to sign up with our
buttons pressing the cancel button where
we're then going to come to the
unselected here and get the value of
false boof you see right there
pressing the same button again saying
log out and then log out here we're
going to get the value of true
wow that was also a lot of information
so i'm just going to go to my notes and
ensure that i've explained everything
that i want to explain
all right
and that was done
now
now that we've displayed amnata we can
actually display a dialog to the user
get the true and false values back we
need to also ensure that we're actually
logging out from firebase as well so the
true or false isn't enough we need to
log out from firebase and the way to do
that as you can see in the code here in
the captions is firebase auth instance
sign out okay
so um
what we need to do then is to call a
function
so we say in here um
let me bring up my notes
so we say if
should log out
then we are going to do that because you
see this should log out says true if you
do have to log out and false if you
don't have to so we just made sure that
it's true okay so you can either say it
should log out or you can say if it
shouldn't log out then return
and then you do the actual log out after
this so it completely depends on your
style i'm just gonna do if should log
out because it makes more like
grammatical sense for me if i should log
out and do this then saying if i
shouldn't log out don't do this
it's a little bit of a preference but
you're free to to choose your own style
as you go on
so let's say firebase off
um instance as we can see here and then
we say sign out
and you can see that it returns a future
avoid
so let's call it and then we say wait
oof all
right and now that we've done that
uh after we sign the user out then
there's no point keeping the user in
this user interface because this user
interface is only for people who are
logged into the application and signing
out from firebase means that well you're
not logged out anymore okay or you're
not signed in anymore sorry you're not
logged in anymore signed in anymore
they could be used interchangeably sign
in or log in and log out and sign up
depends of the lingo that you prefer to
use in your in your project
i also use these terms interchangeably
so if i say sometimes sign out or log
out you know what i mean
all right in this case after you sign up
we also want to send you to the login
screen because that's like the in in my
opinion at least it's the most common
thing to do if you sign out of an
application you then go back to the
login screen okay
otherwise if you for instance are
developing a
website and then there is like a
a forum website or something and
the user goes and logs out you may send
them them to not to the login page but
but you may actually send them to like a
read-only copy of all the forms
available in your in your website but
since we don't have
any content to display to a user who has
signed out the only thing we can display
to them is the login screen because we
don't have any other content to display
okay so upon signing out we're gonna
send you to the login screen so let's do
that now
so we're gonna see navigator
as you can see in the caption of um
of our context
and we're saying push remove push name
and remove until and then we're going to
say login
leave like that
and we don't need the route
and just like that command s
all right does this make sense
so let's then see if this works um
so
let's have a look at that uh let me also
go to my notes to ensure that i'm
explaining
everything
yep
great and let's just make sure that sign
out is working okay so log out we say no
just to test that that is working and
then log out and then we say log out
here and i can see i'm even using the
language like interchangeably here which
is not a good idea are you sure you want
to sign out and then a log out button
it's not perfect but it works
you're free to change this if you want
to and then if you say log out then we
should go back to the login screen
perfect
that is working but something isn't
working quite right and i'll tell you
soon but before we do that let's go to
the terminal and
go to here i have two terminals one for
scr cpy and the other terminal is for
doing commits messages i'm going to
bring up actually so you see it better
so what we need to do as we've done in
the previous chapter is now that we have
git and github
set up let's commit our work and we're
going to call this step three okay
so that's what we're going to do now we
are going to commit our work and we're
also going to tag it
so let's say git status just to have a
look at what we've changed i can see
that there's only changes in the main
dark file and you can also say git if so
you can see what you've changed you see
all the green ones are new and all the
red ones are things that you've
basically removed or replaced with new
content
for instance this one was removed this
one was removed and this one was added
all right so quite a bit of information
here let's say it gets at all so we
add all those to the staging environment
in order to commit them and then i'm
going to say git commit with a message
of step three
and let's have a look at our logs i can
see initial commit which is step one and
then step two and then step three
and then you will push these changes or
push the commits to github all right
now i'm gonna clear that terminal here
and we also need to tag our code
remember commits are not the same thing
as tags so i'm going to say git tag step
and put your tags as well
so that pushed the tags as well great
wow that was a lot of work um
but uh i have to kind of say
congratulations for you to
keep up with me in this chapter as we
went through all these different bits
and pieces that we had to put in place
for the log out to work but like at such
an integral part of our application that
i think it's worth spending some time
explaining how things are working also
talk about a little bit of like basics
of
the show dialogue and menu items pop-ups
etc etc so once we talk about them now
we don't have to talk more about them
later
remember i told you something isn't
quite working right here
and that's what we're going to fix in
the next chapter which is fixing the
login screen and i'll tell you what is
isn't working if you now go in here and
put your email address
and put your password in you can see
pressing login doesn't do anything
it just logs into the application
because if you go to login view and we
have a look at the code that we wrote
here
let me get rid of the console here
if you look at the
button that was pressed upon pressing it
all we're doing is just we're doing a
print user credential and you can see
that if you go here oh i can see i
actually got wrong password so let me go
and say foo barbaz
oh
now we got the user credential here you
see
but still nothing worked even if you
provide the correct user credentials
then
it's not working as it should and by
that i mean it's not taking you to the
next step what should happen in the next
step all right
so
that is what we're gonna fix in the next
chapter we're gonna work on fixing the
login view so for this chapter all you
all you and i did is to
uh take care of our main user interface
we got rid of that ugly uh
done text widget that we were displaying
at the end of the previous chapter
and we have now a main ui with a
menu
bar item on top right and pressing that
displays a
pop-up menu
which has an enum
item in it upon pressing which then you
get a dialog and then if you cancel
um
you go back to the main ui and if you
say log out or sign out you go back to
the long view so there was a lot of work
that we did and congratulations for you
for keeping up
so
uh get ready then and whatever you want
to do get some refreshments and that we
will fix our login screen in the next
chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 19 of the
swata course
in the previous chapter we worked on log
out
and after we completed log out you saw
that we went to the login screen and um
that it wasn't really working as it
should in that
what it was doing is um that it was
logging you in with firebase and it was
printing the user credentials to
the debug console
or the cons basically the console and we
were seeing the logs
but the login view wasn't actually going
to the notes view
so as you can see here it says the login
doesn't route properly it just stays
there and that's
does nothing upon successful login and
that's exactly what we're going to
address in this chapter this chapter is
going to be quite a short one because
all we're basically doing is just doing
some cleanup and we're going to go from
the login screen to um the login view to
the note c and we're going to remove
some um
law
print statements um and this is like
what what is gonna happen as you become
more and more of a software developer
and that sometimes you do the heavy
lifting as we did in the previous
chapter we took care of uh logout
and you learned a lot about new classes
like the buttons and the menus and
unpressed of those menu items and then
after you've done that you'll probably
spend some time to clean up the code and
this is one of those chapters that we're
going to do
a cleanup
so let's have a look at the first thing
that we need to remedy and that is our
print statements
um
let's have a look at the code i'm going
to bring up our code
so i think we call it my nodes so here i
think is the right window
and i'm going to get rid of the debug
console right there and i'm going to
bring up scrcpy
which i have somewhere around here
okay so you can see in login view we
have quite a lot of print statements at
the moment they just say print user not
found wrong password user credentials
and etc
and we also have a register view here
which has a few print statements so
let's go and remedy this and use log as
we talked about it before so let's say
i'm going to change the um
view layout here so you see the code a
little bit better
let's go and use log and if you don't
know the difference between log and
print nice drawing i strongly suggest
that you watch the previous chapters
where we talked about this and why it is
actually advised to use log instead of
print
and login itself isn't perfect it has
it's not
like problems but
not problems maybe downsize or things
that you need to be aware of and i
highly suggest that you read the
documentations for log as well but um in
this case as you can see it's also
suggested by the analyzer not to use a
print so we're going to change that to
both in the login view and registry
we're going to change that to
using log so let's go ahead and say
import dart developer and as devtools
show log all right now i'm gonna copy
paste this in here as well and at the
same time i'm gonna clean up the code a
little bit in register view all right
okay we've done the import in login view
and register you want to save those and
now let's go to the login view and
remove all these print statements and
instead just say devtools
log
and we're just going to say user
credential to string okay remember print
can print an object
if you look at the
information for print here
excuse me
you can see the function signatures is
that i can print an optional
object which is kind of peculiar that it
can print an optional object i mean
um
does it mean that i don't have to
actually pass a parameter no it has a
positional argument but that argument
can be not so i could say
string um
value is null like this like an optional
and just pass that here so i animal
still work that's what it means so let's
have fun it can accept an optional
object
and remember every object has a function
called to string so this two string
functions actually coming from objects
so we can command click on it
and you'll see that uh let's see oh that
this is the two string of
user credential but if we look at um
if we create for instance how do i
explain the tostring and where it comes
from
um
let's let's do it like this let's say we
have an object
optional object value and that is null
now i can say value to string you see
there's a function there
so these are the op these are the
functions and properties that any object
exposes and every class
in dart
is
implicitly a subclass of object
including user credential meaning that
user credential has inherited the
tostring
function from the object class however
if you looked at the source code for
this particular two string you can see
it comes from package firebase off
firebase off the dart meaning that user
credential this class has overwritten
the functionality of tostring meaning
that it is returning its own string to
represent itself all right
and that's this long string that we saw
actually
we can't see it now but let me see if i
can
log in here so you see it poof
and you see this user credential that is
printed right here
let me change the screen layout a little
bit so this user credential
so
this is being printed or this is being
returned and calculated by
the to string function on user
credential and you can see it looks like
this user credential and then additional
information and then prints the
additional information and that's
exactly what you can see here you see
additional user info and then there's
credential which i believe
it should be somewhere around here
is anonymous is here credential that's
the key and then another one called user
and where could that be
it's somewhere in here i can't see it
really but it should be somewhere in
here
user password i mean to be honest if you
copied this like if i actually copied
this and brought it into its own file
and search for user
boom boom let's see
it's a little bit strange that it's all
in one line but that's okay too i'm
going to search for user boom
and that is the user information you can
see user is user display name etc so
that's two string okay the reason i'm
explaining all of this is because you
need to know that print can print an
object but log can't log needs a string
so if you look at the function signature
it says give me a message of type string
okay
so
um that's what we're doing here we're
saying devtools log and then user
credentials to string
we need to do the tostring okay
so go ahead copy this dev tools log and
then
let's change all these print statements
to say that that's what needs to be
printed now or logged
change all of those in your login view
so that you don't have any more warnings
here
related to print okay
save your login view and then go to
register view and do the exact same
thing so
user credentials
needs to be to stream
and for weak password do the same thing
email to the same thing and then invalid
email entered and we have no other print
statements and what you could do i mean
i haven't
had a plan for this uh in
in my notes here i don't see
anywhere that i'd plan for that but i
think we could just
uh
we could just improvise a little bit and
what i really like to do when i'm doing
like cleanups like this in my source
code i like to go and make sure that
there's no print statement statement
anywhere else because it just feels like
when you're clean on cleaning up your
code especially if you're doing
something as simple as what we're doing
here it is worth spending maybe just a
few more seconds and making sure that
you're applying the same cleanup in the
entire source now sometimes your source
code may be so big and complicated that
you changing even a simple bit of code
may affect the source code in such a way
that you may not know if you're breaking
it or anything
so
and for that we need tests unit tests
widget tests etc but if that is the case
you don't have to do that but in this
case since our application is so new
we've just created it there's not much
logic in it i think it's worth maybe
just doing a command shift f
in visual studio on mac or ctrl shift f
it was just here to go on linux and
windows just to go go to this global
search and just search for print
and i can see here that we don't have
any print left in our source code so we
don't have to change anything else all
the prints seem to have been in the
login view and in the register view so
don't worry about that anymore okay
all right
that was for our prints
um so now what we need to do is to
ensure
that
yeah basically we need to now focus on
what we wanted to do in this chapter
that was a side kind of like a
side note there to clean up our print
statements what we need to do in this
chapter to make sure that we can go from
the login view to the
notes view i believe is what we created
in the
and one of the previous chapters um
is it here in the main dart perhaps
let's see
notes view yeah
so let's do that and you remember from
the previous chapters where we oh we
don't need the
devtools log here okay
if you remember from one of the previous
chapters where we talked about named
routes and named routes as you can see
that are defined in the main function
now remember the main function
does not get recompiled
when you do a hot reload keep that in
mind so we're now going to modify our
routes and allow and create a new route
as you can see here it's called nodes
actually it should be node slash
so i'm going to hide this caption
and change it so that it is actually
accurate
like that
um and i'm going to bring it up
again so you see the
correct route that we have to create
okay
so let's go in here and create a new
route for our notes
and anybody who then
that tries to
push this route on the screen will get
the
notes view appear
on their screen okay so let's just say
as a string and notes slash as the
captions suggest and then you have to
provide remember the routes was a map
where the keys were strings and the
values had to be functions that accept
the build context and return a widget
it's a little bit of a string syntax but
you'll get used to so the value should
accept the build context as you can see
here and it should return a widget so in
this case we return the notes view okay
as a constant
okay that part is done now so
what we need to do now is to ensure that
upon pressing the login view sorry upon
press upon pressing the login button
that we are doing a code similar to
what we did in um if you look here in
our login view when we went to register
do you remember this navigator of
context push name and remove until okay
so
we need to we need to do that and
when we do this
when we did this initially when we
worked with push name and remove until i
don't think i actually explained
entirely what push named and remove
until does to be honest
so i'll do that now
as its name suggests it pushes around on
the screen so it says that you have a
screen and you want to put something on
top of it okay so pushing is something
that is very popular in mobile
development because
a mobile screen
usually i mean after ios came um
it became very popular that you had a
screen you press the button and another
screen got pushed on top of that screen
so this has been available i mean in
many other places even web browsers are
not doing it these days and even nokia
phones in in the good old days were
doing the same thing but it wasn't as
popular back then and it wasn't like
coined as a term of pushing until ios
and android became more and more popular
back in 2007
so
pushing is the concept of having a
screen and then
moving and pushing physically another
screen on top of it okay
so that's what push means in push name
all right the named part of this
function means that you have a named
route so you have defined a route
somewhere such as your main screen here
and you are trying to push that using
its name so you're not just pushing a
new widget out of nowhere okay so that's
what the name means
now
the part that says and remove until
what it says is um
if you have for instance one screen here
another one is pushed on top of it and
now you want to push another one on the
screen
what the remove until says it says if
you want to push this one on the screen
i'm going to give you the chance to get
rid of the existing screen on the stack
so i remove these first and then i'll
push yours and this is kind of useful
for for instance if you're let's say you
have a login view
and then you press the login button and
in the in our case when the user
credentials are correct if we then
um
if we then want to go to the notes view
we don't have to keep this logging view
on the screen so if this login view is
here what we could do is to push the
notes via on top of it some nodes view
is always sitting here but then you as a
programmer not the user as a programmer
you'll always know that the
login view is sitting behind this so
that's not so good because once you're
logged in
and you're on the notes view you don't
need this view anymore you don't need
the login view sitting there and
consuming memory so that's what remove
until does because it gives you the
opportunity it passes you see a route of
dynamic and it says let me know when you
want me to stop
move removing things from the screen
before i push yours and us returning
false basically says
just remove everything don't care about
the routes that are on the screen at the
moment and don't care about the routes
that you're telling me about just remove
everything and go to this register view
okay
all right that was a lot of information
hopefully you got that so
now we need to do is to go to our login
view which we are right now and upon
getting our user credentials here what
we need to do is to send the user to the
um
main ui
so i'm just gonna check in my notes that
i've explained everything to you before
we go forward
and yeah that seems to be the case so um
let's then go ahead and do that right
here
what we're going to do is going to get
rid of this dev tools log here okay
let's then go in here and say
and navigator
of and remember we have a build context
and we're going to say push name and
remove until
uh like this and our new route name is
actually what's it called notes i think
we call it right in here yeah slash note
slash
so put put that in there and in here you
could just say
return false okay now
this is one thing of also i haven't
mentioned in the previous chapters but
in dart it is very important that you
always suffix your parameters
parameter values with a
a comma and a comma you can see here
is placed usually between parameters but
also the last parameter is suggested to
have a comma because as you can see here
the dart formatter right now isn't
really able to break this
these two parameters into two separate
lines of code and that's what we usually
do in dart you can see here for instance
when we did a wait on firebase instance
sign in in the last parameter we had a
comma if i remove that the code will
actually be a little bit uglier in this
it looks like this but if you put a
comma at the end of your last parameter
dark is able to break your parameters
each parameter and its value in its own
line and that's like a usual convention
in dart so if you see something like
this that doesn't look quite right put a
comma at the end of the last parameter
and press command s for dark formatter
to be able to format your
uh code okay
great we've done that now
and at the moment we're not using
the user credentials um at all so what
we could do to be honest with you is to
get rid of that so all we'll do is we
say firebase instance sign in with email
and password okay
and um that's it because this whole
thing is in a try block so if this thing
doesn't work properly then we'll come
here okay
now
well this is great actually now we're
gonna go from our
um login view to the notes view but
you'll be a bit disappointed to see that
this isn't going to work as it should so
let me change the
uh ui a little bit here and then press
the login button
and you'll see we get an error here that
says unfortunately on unknown route was
not set
it's quite cute that they say
unfortunately in the
uh in the actual airlocks so
that's what this caption also tells you
you see i i talked about it a little bit
before
when we kind of started with this
chapter that we said that we're going to
put the
login as our the notes
name route in the main function
but
this is i told you that this isn't going
to really work so well the reason is
again the main function isn't going to
rebuild when you do hot reload so
in order for your changes in the main
function to take effect you need to do a
hot restart so what is happening here is
that you've defined everything correctly
everything is done right there's nothing
wrong in the code itself it's just the
way we are executing the code that is
wrong and now you have to do a hot
restart for flutter to be able to pick
up your changes in the main function as
well okay so hot reload is not going to
do it so you need to do a hot restart so
i'm going to do hot restart here
we come here and now you see we're in
the hello world because
we are actually logged in from the
previous section
um i'm going to log out
and we come here now i'm going to enter
my
details
foo bar baths and please don't
use football bats as your password i'm
just doing it for the sake of simplicity
and now we say login and you see that by
doing login we come to the main ui of
the application so and as you saw
pushing in android using material design
isn't the same thing as
pushing on ios let me let me demonstrate
it one more time for you so you'll have
a
good look at it in the login view enter
your information
uh
through barbados and then do log in and
before you do that just have just make
sure that you're focusing very well on
the screen i'm going to bring it up a
little bit more
so you'll see better um look how this
main ui of the application won't
actually be pushed but it instead will
be kind of like moved from the bottom of
the screen to the top while that
previous screen gets faded away so
focus on the screen please
did you see that so
ios and android are going to work
differently differently but the
concept is the same so now that the main
ui is pushed to the screen where an
android is displayed on the screen the
login view has disappeared and been
removed from the view stack okay
so that's great that's all we have to do
in this chapter so i hope actually you
are happy with the results and that we
didn't have to do too much now what we
need to do also we need to make sure
that we do like we did in the other
chapters so let's go ahead and
let's go and commit and tag our changes
all right so we if you look at our tag
um
if you say git tag we have now step one
two three
and this
chapter in this chapter we're gonna
commit our message commit our changes
and tag it with the tag name of step
four so if you look at git log we did
step three in the previous chapter now
we're gonna do step four so let's say
git add
all and you can see it was just a few
files that we changed
now let's um i'm not sorry i'm going to
change the screen layout
i'm also going to say git commit
um
step 4
okay
and um
now let's tag it as well
let's push our changes to uh github and
also let's get a push our tags
like this
so if you say git tag now now we have
four tags and if we do its log
you'll see we have step two three and
four and the initial commit which is
step one all right well done that was
great and work for this chapter quite a
short chapter and sweet um and now we
need to get ready for the next chapter
as you can see in the caption here says
we need to clean up our routes since
they are everywhere
and that means that you can see here
we've defined our routes login register
nodes but also in the login view we're
like redefining we're saying that
actually not redefining we're trying to
like go to the notes route but we're
typing the entire route name again and
this is usually in programming not a
good idea like if you have strings
flying all over the all over the place
like one is defined in the main dart the
other one is called in the login view
and this something similar is used for
instance in the register view as you can
see here
usually this means that you need to um
bring these into one central place and
kind of reuse them and that is exactly
what we're gonna do in the next chapter
so
um let's just
leave it like this and i'll see you in
the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 20 of this
flutter course
in this chapter which is going to be a
very short one i think it's going to be
the shortest chapter of all the chapters
we've done so far we're going to do some
cleanup now
you can see that uh i mean i'll show you
what state we left our code in in the
previous chapter
this is what we've done so i'm gonna
bring up the project uh
files up here
you will see that um the state that we
left our project in was if we go to our
main dart we had some routes defined i'm
gonna
do it like this you'll see it better we
had some routes defined
and um
and one was called a login which the
register view actually uses to send the
user to the login view
if the user already had
a
if the user had already registered and
we don't actually have to
talk
about that without showing it so let's
go here let's go here in the register
view so if the user ends up in the
registry and they
already have a username and
their email and password setup then they
can click on this or tap on this button
that says already registered log in here
and that happens in our
register view here navigator of push
name and then goes to the login route
which is defined in main art and kind of
the same thing happens in the login view
here so if the user doesn't have
their
if the user hasn't registered for our
service then they can actually tap on
not register yet register here button
okay
and that's the register route and the
third route that we have is the notes
route which allows us to send the user
from the login screen to the main ui of
the application which we just call at
the moment
notes view which right now
resides inside main dart and i'll just
have a look at my code here and just to
ensure that that is
what i had intended yeah so we haven't
yet
refactored notes view and we haven't yet
put it into its own file okay
so
let's talk about hard coding now
if you're not a programmer like if you
don't have a software development
background you probably don't know what
hard coding is but
i'll i'll kind of give you the um
i'll give you example maybe in different
worlds that may also
be relevant for a programmer let's say
you're working in figma and you're
working with a design so you have a list
of items to display on the screen and
you create these list designs like you
have a little cell that should be
displayed inside a view then you go and
copy paste this
in 10 different places and then
you talk to the team about the design
that you've created and then they say oh
you'd be really great if this label was
a little bit bigger then what you'd have
to do is to go to every place that
you've copy pasted that
cell and you have to change the label a
better way of doing that in figma if
you're a designer would be to create a
component and then create instances of
that design component in various pages
of your figma design
so if
so you need to update something then you
need to just update it in one place
so
even if you're not coming from a design
background and you're working for
instance as a project this is a product
owner or a project manager you may be
working with some like um
excel sheets and you're creating maybe
um some
graphs now if you create a graph from a
data set
you probably want to reuse that graph in
other places so if someone says okay can
i get like all the graphs available in
the project then you don't go and create
the same graph over and over again you
kind of want to refer to the same sheet
in your
google sheets or your excel sheets so
the concept is the same you don't want
to repeat yourself and that's what the
mistake that we've done at the moment in
our source code in that we have our
routes defined in one place however
where every word we're gonna use these
routes we're writing their names again
and this is one thing
that most programmers do not like
when you become more of a seasoned like
a senior developer then you try to avoid
these things because if we now go to our
main dart file and change this login to
just slash login then we have to search
everywhere in our project for a name
route called slash login slash as it was
before and change that to this new form
and that's not a good idea
that's hard coding and that is why
developers don't like it and i suggest
that you don't like it either
so uh what we're gonna do in this
chapter very quickly hopefully we can
get done with it soon
uh be done with it soon we're gonna
create a new file in our project is the
first file of its kind that we're
creating where we're going to put our
constants okay so constants as you know
from where we talked about dart are
values that don't change during the
compile time
and they don't change during the runtime
either so these are our route names
because they're always constant they're
no one is going in there and changing
them okay
so let's go ahead and do that as a
caption says here let's go create a fox
under lib under folder called constants
and then routes and as i showed you
before you don't have to create the
intermediate directories in this case
constants before you create the route
start file what you'll need to do is
just right click on lib where you want
to create the constants and then the lib
sorry the constants folder and then um
route start file just right click here
say new file then say constants um if i
can spell it um
and then say
routes part
and that will create the constants
folder intermediate folder for you okay
so
what we need now is to define as the
caption says here we need to define
three routes one for the login route one
for register and the other one for the
notes route so let's just say
const login route
and we just say that's equal to login
slash i'm gonna copy paste this and i'm
just gonna in this second one just say
this is
uh register route as the caption
suggests and then the notes route okay
and in here i'm going to say register
and in here you should say also notes
okay so now we've defined these three
routes
but what we need to do now we've defined
them but this is not enough what we need
to do is to actually go and use them so
let's go back to our main dart file and
in here instead of using login we need
to use a login route right and you can
see now visual studio code smart enough
to understand that this is a symbol that
we've defined in a file here
but this symbol right now isn't
available in the current context because
we haven't imported that constant
routes
file
so
if i just
allow visual studio code to auto import
that you can see all of a sudden the
symbol becomes a valid symbol
in my current context and if i go up
here then i should be able to see that
visual studio code has imported this
file for me but if you're if you're
working with veeam or if you're working
with android studio and you're not
given the opportunity to
uh to import you can always go to this
symbol and just say
uh command dot or control dot depending
on your operating system and just say
import that library
and even if your
editor isn't smart enough to do
importing in this way you can import it
yourself so you can just say
um import
package then the name of the application
which is my notes and then you'd say
constants slash routes dot darts so
there you have three ways of solving the
same problem i usually do auto import so
i don't have to type all of that um and
i'm not gonna explain this more than in
the upcoming chapter so you have all the
tools necessary in order to be able to
fix a problem like this okay so in here
i'm going to use register route and
since
uh route start is now imported here
here
then i'm not going to have a problem and
i don't have to auto import anything
okay and for notes i'm going to say
notes route
oh that's great now we've defined them
in our main function however we still
have a few places where we're doing
routing and we're hard coding those
routes so let's fix first our notes view
which is the main ui of the application
so if i type here pixel tab gmail.com
like that and then i say um
login
and we're getting some oh foobar baz
in here when we do log out that's where
we sending the user to the login route
so let's change that as well to say
login route okay so that's one place
uh i'm gonna then say log out here poof
log out
so that's fixed now the other place we
have to fix is in the login view as you
can see here
where we press the not register yet
register here button so let's go to the
login view
in our views in login view
i'm going to get rid of the explorer
there
in the
in this button not registered yet let's
see where it is
here
you see we're sending the user to the
register route so i'm going to send them
instead to register router and you can
see you should code smart enough again
to do auto import so i'm going to take
that option
and also we have another route here
which sends you to notes where you
have successfully logged in so let's
just say notes route okay
so that's for our login view
and now the other place that we have to
fix is in register so go to your project
explorer and then go to register view
and have a look at where we're doing
this login button here okay
and
let's then say instead of
that we're just going to say
login routes okay so
if you now search for push name and
remove until and then show the results
if you click through them you shouldn't
have any routes that is hard coded okay
so
nodes route
register route and the login route so
now we fix this and just remember
because we now have changed the main
function here and we have some routes
here do you have to do hot restart in
order to see your changes but
if everything's working according to the
plan and that we didn't like to make any
wrong choices in our rat names and that
we gave them the same name or anything
which we haven't
if everything is working like it did
before then you shouldn't see any
changes in here so if you enter your
information like you did before
and i say foobar about then i should be
able to log in
should be able to log out
and i should be able to go to register
view or the login view so
it's working exactly as it did before
okay
all right great stuff that was a quick
chapter as other chapters since now we
have made some changes and we've
actually made the code better and we've
tested to make sure everything works
fine it's time to commit our changes as
you can see the previous chapter we
committed our changes as step 4
and in this chapter we're gonna commit
our changes as step five and we're also
going to
um
we're also going to tag it like we did
before
and let me change the
layout as well so you'll see the
terminal a little bit better i'm gonna
do it like this gonna make the terminal
bigger even so you see it even better
so let's go ahead and see what the
status is i can see there are lots of
changes as you can see here it says
you've made changes you modified these
existing files and now all of a sudden
there's a new folder as well so what i
like to do in these cases when there is
a new folder i like to do bits add all
because this adds all the files and
folders
so you can take it at all and if you say
git status now you can see
the new folder including its content is
now added to the staging environment or
the staging area
okay now we've staged so now let's
commit and we say we said that we are
going to commit and tag as step five
so let's say step five um and then get
tag
um step five as well get push your
changes
and then give push the tags as well
all right so if i say you tag now we
have five tags
and if i say gitland we have step five
four three two and then the initial
commit which is pretty much step one all
right so
great stuff well done for going through
this chapter so fast as well together
with me and what we need to do now is to
get ready for the next chapter
and just to give you a little preview
what we're going to work on is to have a
look at our error handling in
specifically the login view so if i make
this a little bit smaller so it's more
digestible you can see at the moment our
error handling the reason i put
quotation marks around it is that it's
not so much of an error handling to be
honest with you what it is doing is just
says if an error of this type happens
then log this message to the console a
normal user sitting with their phone
they don't have access to logs they're
not going to see any logs so logs are
very very much useless for them and what
we're going to do in the next chapter is
actually display meaningful information
to the user
using some alert views and
dialogues so
grab your refreshments if you want to
and i'll see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 21 of this
flutter course
in the previous chapter as you remember
we talked about cleaning up the routes
that we have in our main function and we
put them inside their own dart files so
that they are separate from um so we're
basically not hard coding hard coding
them in different places of the
application
we talked about what hard coding also is
if you're not coming from a software
development background and why it is
usually a good thing not to hard code
your strings and spread them around in
the entire code base
in this chapter we are going to focus on
cleaning up
error handling in our login view to
start with if you remember our login
view at the moment
actually i don't have to say if you
remember because i can bring up the code
so we can have a look at it together
here is our
code
i'm going to bring up scrcpy here as
well so you can see
the android phone working okay
so i'm going to also change a little bit
the um
screen layout so if you remember uh we
have our login view right here probably
have to move some things around here so
it becomes a little bit better layout
let's go to login view and we have then
our
um
lock statements here should anything go
wrong so
if we could sign in with an email and a
password then we were pushing the notes
route onto the screen
but if there was a problem with our
firebase authentication and we got a
firebase auth exception
we are simply at the moment logging that
information to the debug console and
that is not good enough because should
any errors happen for instance if the
current user couldn't be found or that
the password is incorrect
uh your end user will not receive these
logs because they're not running this
application beside visual studio code or
anything like that
except your actual users are going to be
running the application on a normal
telephone such as an android or an ios
or an
ipad even or tablet
so that's what we are going to do in
this chapter we're going to clean up the
logic for our error handling so um
so before you begin with this chapter
just make sure that you're inside your
login view as we are right here and then
ensure that your application or your
user is logged out so if you're in the
main interface of the application or
you're inside the notes view as we call
it ensure that you go to the menu and
then you log out of the application also
make sure that your telephone or your
emulator simulator also has internet
connectivity so
you can actually hit firebase back end
[Music]
okay
so as you've seen in our login view and
register view we have logic that tries
to handle
different kinds of errors that may arise
for instance in the registration view we
have weak password handling and we have
email already in use or an invalid email
error handling
and so here we have three error handling
and also in login view we have two error
handling and
aside from these we also need to handle
the case of any other exception that
might arise in this try block and we
don't have that at the moment you can
see we're only catching firebase off
exceptions so we have to have a generic
catch block at the end of our try
statement in the login view
and another catch block which is a
generic catch block at the end of the
try statement on our register view three
three uh
auth exceptions plus and a generic
exception handling here four total in
register view
plus two here six and a generic one here
seven so we are going to handle seven
types of errors that might occur during
login and registration and for any one
of these we are going to display an
alert to the user so we're just gonna
alert the user that something has
happened and it needs to be taken care
of okay
so let's go then into um
have a look at
the end of your main dart file and you
can see we already have a future bowl
show log out dial again this is a log
out this is a dialog
that you can see is an alert dialog that
at the moment just returns a boolean
what we need is a
future void as the caption shows here a
function that says show error dialog and
it has a context and a string to display
to the user so we're just going to use
it generically generically from anywhere
in the application okay
so for now i need you to go to your
login view
and at the bottom of the login view
we're going to create the function
signature for this so let's just say
future void
and as i've called it here show error
dialog and we're going to get a build
context called context and then we're
also going to say string text okay
just like this
and remember you can always put a comma
here to complete the um
to make sure that the dart formatter
actually formats your functions
correctly all right
so remember
show error dialogue uh what it needs to
do all it has to do is just to create a
dialogue and then display it so to do
you i mean you may think that you always
start with the creation of the dialogue
but in fact you need to first think
about returning the result of the
dialogue which is in cases of void so
you do that using um
show dialogue so say
return show dialog
and the context is available for you as
a parameter to your function and also
let me should i make this a bit bigger
or is the size okay i think this size is
actually quite enough
so
now that we have that let's then go and
say that we want to have a builder
and your builder i'm going to get help
from visual studio code to complete this
you see it takes the um it brings the
build context in as a parameter and it
expects you
to return let's get the documentation on
it and expect you to return a widget and
the widget that we're gonna have to
display in our short in our show dialog
is an alert dialog so let's go create
that alert dialog
all right so
um
for the title of our alert dialog since
this is as you can see from the
function signature here that says show
air dialog this is this dialog is
explicitly going to be used and
exclusively gonna be used for displaying
errors to the user so something has
happened
and we need to handle that error okay so
we are going to in this case write a
specific very specific title for our
alert dialogue that the user understands
something bad has happened and it needs
their attention
so for the title we're just going to say
a constant text remember the title
property if you just move your mouse
over you can see it's a widget it's not
a string you actually can configure the
title to be whatever you want so this is
the beauty of
flutter almost everything is a widget so
you'd expect oh the title should just be
a string but no you can configure the
title to be exactly what you want so it
can just be an icon if you wanted to so
so let's in here in the text say an
error
occurred
and then we're going to go for the
content
of this
dialogue remember the content comes in
here as the text as a string so let's
wrap that inside a text
widget and we just say we display the
text in there okay
and for the actions
we're gonna go here
and let's for the actions then say we're
gonna create a text button remember the
text button has two parameters
one is its um
file the other one is unpressed the text
button always has to have both these
parameters set all right
so
what do we want to do on the unpressed
we're going to just create the um
function signature for it and for its
child we're just going to say text
and let's just say okay
okay
um so
now we have that set up
and uh let's just do some formatting in
there so let's think about what we need
to do on the on press just remember this
dialog is just going to be displayed to
the user the user is just going to get
the information such as we're going to
display an alert saying that oh
um your password is too weak or uh hey
this user already exists or this email
already exists or incorrect password so
it's just text and then ok button so
pressing the ok button the only thing is
going to do is just going to dismiss the
alert dialogue so only thing you need to
do in here is just to say navigator of
your context and then you'll just pop
this ensures that your dialogue then
gets dismissed now
i've done some videos about this before
on linkedin and twitter i've done live
videos about this where we talked about
a better way of displaying error
dialogues because
this way of displaying error dialects is
a little bit limited
in that then the
pressing of the button dismisses the
dialog however sometimes you may need to
have persistent dialogue displayed on
the screen even when you push new
screens on top of other screens so
it's a little bit strange that a
dialogue is doing navigation in that it
tells navigator to pop
a better way of doing this is using
overlays but overlays are a little bit
complicated for this part of the course
so we're not going to talk about
overlays right now let's just say now we
have a generic dialogue that can display
a text with a title of an err occurred
okay
all right so that is in place now and
now let's go to the next item that we
need to handle here
and that is to handle user not found
so if we go to
our um
sorry i just need to have a look at my
notes to ensure that i'm telling you
everything that i i was supposed to tell
you
all right so in here on your login view
in the case that the error is used or
not found we are going to display an
alert to the user using our new function
okay so in if e code user not found
instead of devtools log we're going to
say
show error dialog the context is already
available for us because you see it is
passed inside
your build function already so you don't
have to grab it from anywhere else it's
available right there and for a text
we're just gonna say user not found okay
and close the string you can see now if
i format this um code these two
parameters are displayed on the same
line as i mentioned in the previous
chapter all you have to do for the dart
formatter to be able to format this code
correctly is put a comma at the end of
the last parameter and just press
command s and it will format it again
for you so each parameter goes into its
own separate line
okay um in case of the so now that we've
handled user not found okay so we could
literally test that let me do a hot
restart just to ensure every piece of
code is injected into the binary that is
running in the application
let's go and place an email that doesn't
exist so that we get the user not found
and let's just enter some password and
then i'm going to press the login button
and you can see now we get our error
displayed on the screen that says an
error occurred user not found and you
can press the ok button to get rid of
the
um the dialog and getting rid of the
dialog is happening here you see
pressing that button says navigator of
context pop so
that's what is happening there
all right great stuff what we need to do
now is to handle wrong password as well
and this one is going to be a breeze
because we've already handled user not
found so what you can do is copy and
paste this code that was placed here in
the user not found statement and bring
it here and replace this devtools log
wrong password with that and instead of
saying user not found what we're going
to say is going to say wrong credentials
okay
so let me now go and
try to log in you can also do that at
home or wherever you're watching this
course from you can enter the email
address of a user who's already
registered with your application so like
if you're testing you may enter the
email address of the person that or your
own email address if that's what you're
testing with but enter the wrong
credentials so there we go
and then press login and now you can see
that message being printed to the screen
wrong credentials okay
all right perfect now um
what we also need to do
um
[Music]
is handle other firebase authentication
exceptions
and you can see here in this case we're
saying if there is a firebase auth
exception and if the code is used or not
found or if the code is wrong password
however there might also be an exception
that you haven't accounted for and
although these are the most known error
codes that you can get there's always a
possibility that there will be another
error code in the future maybe not now
that you will receive from firebase
which you haven't accounted for in that
case
the code then goes in here and says oh
the code is not user not found
is not wrong password and it will just
fall through meaning that this entire
code will this entire catch block will
not be able to catch the actual
exception and your code will crash
so it is very or you will actually get
an error screen
so
it's very important that you
think about your exception handling
early on so you don't send out a code to
production that doesn't have proper
error handling okay
so um
that's what we're going to do
so two things we need to do we have to
handle other exceptions that might occur
and also other firebase off exceptions
so let's do those things
so um
actually we need to first do this so
let's first take care of other all
firebase auth exception so place an else
statement in here and then in that case
just display a dialog
like i'm doing here and for the error
we're just going to say error and then
in here
e dot code
now you may not be familiar with this
syntax from before because maybe i
haven't explained this before but this
is like string formatting and guardian
is very elegant it's also available i
mean kind of the same thing is available
in almost every language that i work
with swift it's available in python when
you're working with django it's
available in ros it's available in
javascript javascript so
you're basically escaping a string and
injecting some actual variables inside
that all right
so in python for instance you would do a
f which means you're formatting and
you'd be like hello
and you would i think you would say
dollar
value
and then you would put your value at the
end something with a percentage sign
something like that and in javascript
you will do
back quotes like this so and in swift
you will do something like this uh e
code like that inside a string so this
is basically a way for dark to inject an
actual code
inside your string
and you can see
in the case of firebase auth exception
the e becomes then a firebase auth
exception and every
exception of this type has a code of
type string
and this is us basically injecting that
string inside our own string so every
code then will be prefixed with the
value of error and then a double double
column here and then space and the code
string itself
now that we've done that we also need to
handle the case where the exception is
not a firebase auth exception and that's
the next point that we need to talk
about
so in here uh at the end of this
on firebase auth exception block and if
you're kind of like unsure where things
start and then you can see that as you
go to this
end of this curly bracket here you can
see that visual studio code has
highlighted this curly bracket right
there saying that this is the beginning
of the code and even if that's not
enough for you you can always go to
visual studio codes and
gutter on the left hand side and like
collapse these pieces of code
so you can see oh
here here you can easily see them you
can also i think
can we not collapse this entire if
no we can't collapse that entire thing
but anyway so at the end of this we need
to do now is
just to say catch e
this is a generic catch block meaning
that if
the exception that occurs in the try
statement is not a firebase auth
exception then go into this catch block
and in this cache block now e you can
see is an object so it's not like a
normal exception anymore it's just any
object because if you remember when we
talked about exceptions in dart you can
throw pretty much anything in dart as an
exception you can even throw an
enumeration value so
that's why it's telling us saying that
any except any other exception other
than this is just an object it's not
known to me i don't know what it is so
it's up to you now to display that error
now if you remember from before from the
previous chapter objects all have a
function called tostring
so that's perfect then we can go here
let me expand these so that they don't
become a little bit cryptic like they
did
and paste that code to display a show
error dialogue again in here also we're
just going to say
e to string
just like that right
so
we we're handling wrong credentials with
handling any other error that might
arise and also sorry any other firebase
exception
of exception and any other exception in
general that might arise during logging
the user in
all right
that was a lot of information i
understand and i move past this quite
fast since when we talk about one thing
like we've already talked about
displaying dialogues i don't think it's
worth your time and my time to spend too
much time explaining all of these over
and over again and so
and that's why i move past these
sometimes quite fast
what we need to do now is to do some
cleanup because you see now we have our
login view m here
sorry login view dart file here and the
m in visual studio code means modified
since we last committed this into git
and we have that file however we also
have the show error dialog that is
sitting here that is also going to be
useful for the register view however
it's right now just sitting in the login
view so if register view wants to then
use this same code you will have to
import the login view and then use this
feature it's a little bit wrong this is
supposed to be like a generic show error
dialogue and it should be available for
pretty much any piece of code that needs
it so what we were going to do as a
caption says here we're going to create
a new file
um and folder as i can see under lib
so open your project explorer under lib
go and create and you can see here we
need to create a file called show error
dialog dart and it's it needs to be
inside
a folder called utility so i'm going to
right click on lib and say new file and
i'm just going to type utilities
slash
show error dialogue dart
all right
and go to your login view and grab that
code
uh for show error dialogue uh poof
i'm gonna grab the code
and cut it
however you cut in your operating system
in mac is command x in visual studio
code and bring it into your show error
dialog file all right we're gonna get a
lot of uh errors but as i've explained
in the previous chapters we can also
import these things material dart to get
rid of almost actually all of those
errors so that was fantastic
now that we've done that you can see
visual studio is already showing this
tab the login view as having an error
and that is because login view is using
show error dialog but now that we've
removed show error dialog from there it
doesn't know where this show error
dialog now resides
so what we need to do is to use our new
file in the login view dart file
and you could do that you could ask
visual studio code to help you with this
and you could just say import library
and
that's it it imported it for us
as you can see
now that we're we don't have any more
logs inside our login view
visual studio code is helping and saying
you're no more using you're no longer
using the dev tools or the dart
developer
package import
what you can do is just to safely remove
that and clean up your imports as well
while we're going okay
so um
that is working fine and we can just
confirm that so i'm just going to enter
an existing email here
with the wrong credentials and just to
ensure that we're getting the dialogue
wrong credentials okay
perfect
now that we've done that i'm going to
change the screen layout a little bit
and what we're going to do is that we
need to wrap up this chapter we've
cleaned up our error handling and we
need to just make a commit remember
pretty much in every chapter from a few
chapters uh back onwards we're to commit
our code at the end of the chapter just
to make sure that you have traceability
for for your code and this is what you
will need to do even if you're working
for instance actually especially if
you're working inside a
a team with other people doing flutter
code or any other code you need to
ensure that your code which is ready or
even if it's not ready it is committed
so um
even if your code isn't ready you can
commit it into a specific branch but you
should never leave your work day
without committing your work remember
that okay
so let's now go and commit our work i'm
gonna bring up the terminal a little bit
here so and you can see that the
previous chapter we did a step five
and in here we're going to commit our
work as step 6 and also we're going to
tag our work okay
so let's say git status you can see
utilities is a new folder i'm just going
to say git add all i'm going to increase
the size of the screen as well so you
see it better
make your studio code a little bit
larger as well
clean
and get add dash dash all and then git
status now you can see these are staged
for committing and i'm going to commit
them as step 6 i believe
after doing that let's tag it as well as
step six
um and get push our changes and we're
also gonna push tags
all right that is absolutely perfect
so that was that to be honest with you
for this chapter so this was a quick
chapter as well and that's completely
okay actually quite refreshing to have
these short chapters for me as well
um
so now that we've done error handling in
our login view
we also need to clean up our register
view you can see our registry has kind
of the same problem
as login view had at the beginning of
this chapter in that we have a lot of
error like dev tools log stuff in here
which aren't so useful so for the next
chapter um
what we need to do is to ensure that
we're logged out of the application and
that we can go to the register view as
we can do here so that's where you need
to be for the next chapter and before we
can continue with that
with the course to the next chapter so i
hope you enjoyed this chapter and i'll
see you in the next one
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 22
of this flutter course
in the previous chapters we've been
talking quite a lot about login and
register and email verification and as
you saw in the previous chapter and we
have some problems still in our register
view in that when we come to
the
error handling we're still doing logs
basically instead of using our new
function that was called show error
dialog
and also our register view basically
isn't really able to send us to the
correct place after a successful
registration you see we have email
verification set up in that every user
who registers also needs to
verify his or her email before entering
the main ui of the application so if
that is the default behavior in that a
newly registered user needs to verify
their email perhaps it would be best
that we
send the user right after registration
to the email verification view and these
are the things that basically we're
going to solve in this chapter fixing
our log statements in the register view
and also sending the user to the email
verification view
sending the registered user to the email
verification view right after
registration okay
so these are the goals of this chapter
so you know and i'm gonna bring up my
visual studio code to the screen so you
can also see it i'm gonna bring up scr
cpy to the right hand side so you see
you see that too position these windows
a little bit better
alright so
the first task that we we need to do
here is to make sure that we're using
show error dialog in our
register view
and if you haven't watched the previous
chapter that's what we did in one of the
previous chapters that we talked about
this uh file here in utilities show
error dialog that increase the size of
the window so you see it better
so this show error dialog is a generic
dialogue that
has a title that says an error occurred
and also a text of your choosing
so let's go to our registry view as the
caption says here i'm going to minimize
the terminal here and get rid of the
explorer
and let's go to this weak password and
then start typing
show error dialog and you can see it's
gonna auto import it
excuse me
it's going to auto import it for us so
let's say show air dialog with that
context
and i'm just going to in this in the
case of a weak password
um
we need to just say weak password okay
so that part is done and you can also
put a comma at the end of the second
parameter just to make sure that it is
clean but remember also that show error
dialogue is a
is an asynchronous function so if you
move your mouse over it you'll see that
it says future void so by just calling
show air dial like you're not showing
the error dialogue you're basically just
telling the short i like to return the
future which in turn then uh can display
the error dialogue if you await on it so
don't forget a wait
after doing that let's remove our dev
devtools log from there from the weak
password and if statement
and
now what we're going to do is to copy
this code that we wrote here and go to
email already in use and display another
error dialog in here using the same
exact code and i'm just going to say
email is already in use okay
so that's for email rna news and also
for invalid email we're going to say
just invalid
let me have a look for invalid email if
you should just say
um this is an invalid email address
right
and i can see that we haven't really
handled other exceptions that might
occur because you remember in the login
view
we had a look at
handling for instance other uh
other exceptions that might occur like
firebase off exceptions that we did in
an else statement there and also we did
a generic catch statement that catches
any other exception that is not a
firebase auth exception and i can see
now we haven't done that in register
view so let's go and take care of that
so let's just say else
so in this else statement we're catching
any other firebase off exception that
might occur okay so i'm just going to
say here
and i'm just going to say
error
and dollar e code okay so that's very
similar to what we're doing in
our login view
so
and i apologize i could just see that
you couldn't see the code because it was
hidden behind the caption but now you
can see it so i'm putting an else
statement here and then i'm saying
basically a weight shorter dialogue and
e code so
that's for if you if you look at have a
look at this um
curly bracket right here which you can
now see this purple one it it starts
here because it's the beginning of where
we start catching firebase off
exceptions
and
what we also need to do is put another l
another catch statement here which
catches any other exception that is not
a firebase auth exception okay
so we've covered this in the previous
chapter when we talked about exception
handling in the login view so i don't
think i need to explain that again um
okay so what we're going to do in here
we're also going to show the error
dialog in this case as well but for the
message we're just going to say e2
string okay
similar something similar we did in
our login view actually exactly the same
thing
okay that was great so now we're using
short error dialog instead of log in the
register view and now
basically i don't think we're using dev
tools
over using devtools login here i don't
think we need to do that anymore so we
can get rid of that
and we can also then get rid of devtools
um
import over here okay
it's gonna have a look at my notes a
little bit just to ensure that i'm
telling you all the information that you
need to know
that's great okay
um now that we've done all of this we
need to also
make sure
you can see as the cache that says after
every registration we need to confirm
the user's email and that is like the um
the pattern of every
newly registered user in application
that
a newly registered user cannot have
already confirmed their email because
it's just not possible the two don't go
together a newly user a newly registered
user hasn't had their email address
registered in our system therefore has
not received a verification email during
this session so
this is a pattern that we need to
basically help our users with so after
every successful registration we're then
going to automatically send the user to
the verify email view and if you
remember from the previous chapters we
have this verify email view right here
which is its own stateful
widget and
i mean it doesn't necessarily have to be
a stateful widget i can see it's not
doing anything stateful but we've just
left it that state will stay full widget
and it can just be like that for now
um but we can also turn it into a
stateless widget if you want to
um okay
so that's for the pattern of what our
users are doing with the register view
so if we go to register here
uh oops no we are actually on the
register sorry about that so
um okay so what we need to do now is
since we're gonna send the user from the
register view we're gonna send to the
verify email view we need a route for
that and if you remember from the
previous chapters we're defining our
routes now inside this file lib
constants routes
dot dart
and we've right now defined login route
register route and nodes route
then we need a new route for the verify
email view so let's go ahead as the
caption says in here and just type that
and just say cons verify
email
out is
slash verify email like that with a
slash at the end as well
now that we've defined the route
we need to then go excuse me we need to
go into our main dart file so i'm going
to close this file close this file and
then command p on mac in visual studio
or or control p in linux and windows and
go to main.dart
okay
in your main.dart you remember all the
routes were registered inside the routes
parameter of your material application
so let's go ahead and register the um
email verify email wrap here
and we say context and we just say const
verify email view
and so that's also then registered
inside the main function okay
remember anything that you're doing
inside the main function is not going to
be reloading when you do hot uh
hot reload so you need to do a hot
restart here in order for for those to
for for those changes in the main
function to take effect so i'm just
going to do a hot restart here
okay
so
let's now that we've registered that
let's go to our register and now that
we've registered there are so many
registered words i'm throwing out there
so i just want to clarify now that we've
registered to verify email routes in our
routes in main dart we need to go to the
register view and use this verify email
route in there after a successful
registration okay
so um
let's then go to our
i'm going to close this and i'm going to
go to
register view
right here
okay
here i can see that we're
getting the user credentials and then
assigning it to this user credential we
don't have to do that anymore so let's
just remove that
we are not going to actually use the
returning user credentials upon a
successful create user with email and
password we're going to go to the next
line automatically because we have a try
and catch statement here
so
now what we need to do is
uh we're gonna show the verify email
route okay
uh
so let's go uh
to our
uh verify email around in here and what
we're going to say is to say navigator
and
dot push
navigator of context
and then we're going to say push named
and you see in this case we're actually
going to say push name instead of using
the other functionality that says push
name and
remove until
and the reason behind this is that
um
when when a user is inside the
registration page here
and when we want to go to the
let's say that you enter some email in
here and then you enter some password
and you click the register button or you
tap the register button
and we send you to the verify email page
where we say oh
um
here you can verify your email et cetera
now in there if you if you realize that
oh i register with the wrong email you
need to be able to go back to the
register page so in order to avoid
having all these buttons that go send
one user from one page to the other it
would make a lot more sense if he from
the register view could just push the
new uh email verification route so we
don't replace the entire routes like the
register page with the new route so
basically the desired effect here is
that our register page is gonna stay
right here and then we're gonna push the
verify email route on top of it if the
user in the verify email route realizes
that they've done something wrong with
the email address then they can just
press the back button on the top bar and
go back to the register page so that
it's just a natural
way of navigating between screens so
that's why we're using push named in
this case okay
so i'm gonna say push names and push
name and and then in the name we're just
gonna say verify
email route oops and verify email route
like this
i'm gonna do a command s right there and
um
then let's make sure that we can put all
of this in action all right so i'm gonna
hot restart just to make sure you
remember we did a
change in our main function so if you
forgot to do hot restart please do that
now um so that your changes can actually
take effect from the login view which is
the first view that the user sees we're
gonna go to the register page
and inside this register page i'm going
to register with a new user so since
i've already registered my user and i
can actually go to firebase console so
let's go to console firebase
the user which i usually use is already
registered with this application so my
notes flutter project okay
let's go to authentication and i can see
pixelityab gmail.com is already
registered so i'm going to register with
a new user in here i'm going to say
van.mp
and the password is foobarbaz i'm just
going to choose here and please don't
use this password in production for any
of your accounts anywhere at all this is
just a bad idea i'm using fubar bass for
consensus consistency and and for the
sake of simplicity in this project so
because for me it's a lot easier as i'm
typing and writing all the passwords
over and over again just to use
fullbarbass but this is not a good
password so i think just to make this
clear
um now i'm going to register this user
and now you can see that
after a successful registration now
we're ending up in this verify email
screen and this is really good
and but
there is a way we can actually make this
better and let's go to firebase here and
i can see now that user is already
registered here you see and it has a
user id
and here's the last sign-in date okay
so
how can we make this better you see
if this is the natural flow of going
like when the user is in the register
page or the register view and they
always end up in the verify email page
the way that we can make this better
is um
that upon successful registration right
before we push the
verify email
view on the screen
is that we actually send a verification
email to that user because otherwise
what you're creating you're creating a
logic for the user that they have to
take an extra step in order to verify
their account so they come here and now
they have to press another button but it
would be really good if you actually did
that button press kind of for them
before we went to that screen so
we're not actually going to physically
like tap that button for them but we're
going to execute the same code that that
button executes for the user okay
so that's what we're gonna do now so um
as the caption says in here in your
register view right before you navigate
to the verify email route ensure that
you get the current user basically so
you say
final user is firebase off
instance i believe and current user okay
get your user
and then in here
you'll say user um and
there is a function called send email
verification and remember your user is
an optional user and that's why you're
seeing this elvis
operator here which is kind of like a
moustache or something i don't know what
you want to call it some some people
call it elvis operator if you're coming
from kotlin or in swift you would say
like an optional invocation depending on
the language that you're coming from but
if you're not if you don't i have like a
software development background then you
may just call that a question mark
um remember now
so user is optional and this function
returns a fusion voice so you can't just
call it you need to wait on it and
so now we're doing that so we're now
awaiting on that all right
and also since now we've changed our
logic in that when you press the
register button upon successful
registration we're sending you an email
verification
is not a good idea to end up on this
screen that just says please verify your
email address because let's let's just
face it we have already sent an email
verification so we don't want the user
to click this button actually we want
the user to click this button or tap
this button
if they haven't received the email in a
while all right so we don't want like
double emails for users so it's just not
a good idea
so uh sorry i'll just have a look at my
notes a little bit here
okay so what we need to do now is as the
caption now says here we need to go to
our
verify email view and add a text on top
to say we have already sent a
verification email okay and that's just
common sense okay
so let's go to our
verify email route which is basically
verify email view in here
and you can see that we have a column in
here and the first text at the moment
says please verify your email address so
let's create another text in here i'm
going to say cons text
and i'm going to say
weave
you see because i want to write the word
weave as in we have there is a single
code in here so i cannot have my own
string having single codes because then
dart doesn't understand where
this what this string is because it
thinks here's a string that starts here
and it ends here but what is this one
so in in order to have single quotes
inside your dark strings then you would
have to
encapsulate or
basically put your string inside double
quotes so you avoid that confusion
so we can say we've
sent you an email verification
please
please open
it in order
to verify your yeah so please open it to
verify your
uh
accounts
something like this okay
and also this text then we need to
change that as well because you see we
don't want this text to be kind of like
a call to action saying that hello
like here we're saying we sent you an
email verification please open the
verifier again and then right after that
we're saying hey click this button so
that's not a good idea let's just change
this text and say
if you haven't
and let's make this double quotes as
well just the same story as before
if you haven't
received a verification
email
yet
press
the button below something like this
okay so i'm just gonna press command s
and now you can see those texts being
displayed on the screen they're not very
pretty to be honest with you at the
moment but that's okay too so
um that's not a problem let it be like
that
all right so we're displaying that text
uh to the user and what we need to do
now uh
is to test this whole uh
flow basically again just to make sure
that yeah it's working as expected so
in order to do that go to your firebase
console again
and i'm gonna bring up the console in
here hopefully you can see it too and
i'm gonna go to that project then
authentication and this user i'm gonna
delete this user okay delete
boof
all right that user is gone i'm gonna
close the screen now
and and what we're gonna do then is just
to hot restart the application in order
to clean all the states
um to restart
is it not taking effect
all right i'm gonna then uh verify email
i can see that there is no back button
and it kind of feels like
uh we're ending up in in that screen
because in our main dart file
and let's go in main dart
i believe that we're actually sending
the user to verify email view in this
case user firebase instance card okay
so this is a lot a little bit a bit of a
problem because now we're kind of like
stuck in this uh
in this
view because firebase as a caption right
here says it says firebase doesn't
understand the remote changes
we removed that user completely but
firebase still believes that that user
exists and that is because you see
firebase can't like the client that is
inside the code that is inside the
client application which you are
developing can't constantly talk with
firebase and say give me the latest
state give me the latest state
this user that is right now on this on
this phone
is a local user that once had a
connection with the backend but it
doesn't anymore but firebase doesn't
like delete this user locally so
so what we need to do
the best way to handle this case is to
have kind of like a restart uh
button in our verify email so if for
some reason the user like in this case
understands that hey um i'm stuck
i need to get out of here from verify
email i kind of want to go back to where
i was so what we need to do is to
upon the user pressing a restart button
here we want to
sign that user out so firebase
understands well this user isn't signed
in anymore so that we don't end up in
this case that email is verified etc etc
and we also are going to send the user
to the register view okay and as you can
see
we can't send the user back to the
register view
i mean that we can't expect the register
view to exist on the view
on the view stack in this case because
if a user has just freshly started the
application application so they will end
up in this future builder the future
builder would then check the user and
says oh you should go to the verify
email view and in this case there is no
register view behind the
um verify email view so in that case you
will see that we won't push but we will
actually do push name and remove until
but we will get there soon okay
first off let's go to your uh to your
verify email view and right after this
text button we're gonna add another text
button
up a little bit so you see it better
and let's just say a text button
unpressed is just going to be empty for
now and then for his child we're going
to add a const text that just says
restart okay
so that's that and then here what we
then need to do is as i mentioned before
is to uh and as the caption
explains here we need to actually log
the user out so let's say firebase auth
instance
and and then what we need to do is to
say sign out
okay remember cyano i also believe is a
future of void so you need to await on
it so oops
um see i just jumped screens without
actually really wanting to do that so
let's wait on it and it's going to give
you an error because now your unpressed
function is not async so make it async
right
after doing that using if i do command s
now we're gonna see the restart button
here but
doing that just does a sign out it
doesn't actually send you to the
register view and we're gonna take care
of that soon so as a caption says
navigator of context i push named remove
until and in here we're going to send
the user to remember from our routes
view sorry a routes file there is a
register route okay so let's go there
let's go register
out and in here we just leave the code
as it is and i come at the end to clean
it up a little bit and
and that should be good to go
okay now i'm gonna do a hot restart
you'll see now we end up in here
and because it's still the user is
logged in because we haven't executed
this code yet and i'm just gonna then
press the restart button and you'll see
we end up in the register view just to
make sure that we're not going to go
into this
vicious cycle again that every time we
do a hot restart we're going to end up
in the verify email view
and let's just do a hot restart now to
see what the state of the application is
going to be and as you can see upon hot
restart we end up in the login view
which means that the main dart file in
the future builder it went to this code
so the user is null at the moment and
that's exactly what we wanted because we
signed the current user out okay
all right so we are then going to use
the same credentials to um
as before to register let's just go to
the register view then and i'm going to
say
round.np np gmail.com and then fubarbas
and i'm going to then register this user
and you can see it says it sent you an
email verification please open it to
verify and i can see on my third screen
here that i actually got the email
um verification
so
as you can see in the caption it says
get the confirmation email but don't
confirm yet because we kind of need to
have a look at a problem that we have in
our application
so um
now let's see if we can log in so what
i'm going to do is to
go back on the screen from the verify
email go back to the register view and
instead of doing a registration again go
to the login view now use your current
uh
like the new user that you just created
but you haven't confirmed the email use
the credentials of that user and say
gmail.com and foobar as
and then press the login button
you'll see now we've ended up in the
main ui of the application
and that is problematic because
any user just like i did can go to the
register view then they will go to the
confirmation view automatically they say
okay i got a confirmation email and then
they don't confirm the email they press
the back button to go to the registry
view again and from registry google they
go to the login view and then they log
in so
because you see in our login view
and here in this code
right after signing with email and
password we are not verifying that the
user has actually verified their email
address we're just saying sign in and
firebase says all right sign in great
the email and password match an entry in
the authentication database i'm good to
go and then we're just saying push to
notes wrap so
that is a problem um
that we have that we need to fix in the
next chapter okay
but for now we've got a lot of code i
can see all the files are changed so
let's commit our code and tag it like
what we're doing in other chapters as
well
gonna go to the terminal i'm going to
change the screen layout a little bit so
you see it better
increase the size of the
views so you see it even better
and you can see the previous tag was
step 6. now let's have a look at the
status of our code and i can see there's
lots of changes modified you can always
issue the command g apa
which i call gopa and that will show you
all your changes but i'm just gonna say
git commit sorry good at all
i'm going to say git commit and we said
that we're going to commit this as step
7 okay
and push those changes to github
and i'm going to also tag it as step 7
so like that step seven and then i'm
just gonna say git push tags
all right fantastic now
as the caption says here we need to get
ready for the next chapter and as you
can see it says user needs to verify
email before going to the main ui
because that is as i explained there is
a problem that we have which we haven't
addressed yet but it's quite easy to
address as you'll see in the next
chapter so
uh i'll see you there
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 23
of this vlog course as you saw in the
previous chapter we talked about
cleaning up our registration flow so
that when we tap on registration or the
register button we actually send an
email confirmation to the user and we
saw that we go to the email confirmation
view and before we even get there we
then receive our email confirmation in
our inbox so that all worked very well
except for the fact that now a user who
hasn't registered who hasn't verified
their email account can still end up in
the main ui of our application and
that's what we're going to fix in this
chapter so
as the
title shows here or as the caption shows
here what we need to do is to ensure
that
we first before we continue with the
chapter we need to make sure that we've
logged out of the application so um
now that you're in the main ui of the
application let's just go in here and
say log out and we're logging out to end
up on the login screen
i'm gonna i'm also gonna bring up visual
studio code as we left it before
so
what we need to do now i'm going to
close
other tabs except for the login view
excuse me
and you can see in here
right after we're signing with email and
password right now we're sending the
user to the notes route and we need to
clean this up so
what we need to do is just to get the
current user from firebase
and
i'm gonna bring up
the correct correct caption as well and
i'm gonna change the screen layouts a
little bit um
so you see the code better
so as you can see the caption says you
need to add an if statement before you
send the user to the main ui of the
application
and to make sure that the user is
verified okay so
in order to do that we also need to get
the
concurrent user so we can say final user
is equal to firebase off instance
firebase off instance
and the current user okay so that's for
the current user
and we're going to say if the user
optional you see we need to optionally
access that email verified or false
when we get a boolean value here either
this returns a true or reuse false
so in here we say user's email is
verified
otherwise user's email
uh
if i can spell it is not verified okay
so now we have the two conditions in
there
so what we need to do now is to grab
this code that we had from before you
can see it sends the user to the main ui
of the application and of course that
needs to happen only if the user has
basically
verified their email address so grab
that code and place it in user email is
verified okay in here
and in the case that the user email is
not verified then we kind of need to do
the same code
but instead of going to the nodes route
which is the main ui of the application
we actually know we need to go to the
verify email route if you remember from
the previous chapters in a route start
we've already defined verify email route
okay
so
let's go back in our login view and then
paste the same code except for going to
notes route we're gonna go to and verify
email routes okay
so
really all we have to do for this
chapter so it's just cleaning up the
logic one step at a time okay and that's
okay some chapters are going to be long
some chapters are going to be short it's
actually quite refreshing even for me to
have some shorter chapters so
um now what we need to do is let's put
this to test
and as you can see what we're going to
do is to remove that test user again
from firebase console and test the
entire flow again so i'm going to do a
hot restart here
and just to make sure that the state is
completely restarted i'm gonna bring up
a firebase console let's go to our
application which for me is called
mynotes flatware project
i'm gonna go to authentication and
remove that test user that i created
here okay delete
and do another hot restart just to make
sure the cache is invalidated if there's
any cache in there
and
what we need to do now is to just oops
what we need to do now is to do kind of
like the same registration again so i'm
gonna go to the register page here and
then i'm gonna go to your enter your
email here
and i'm going to
write the same email address to register
the user again through bar bath
press the register button
and we end up here then i'm going to do
the same hacked as we did before uh
press the back button and then go to the
login screen i'm going to type the same
credentials and say fubar baz if
everything is worked according to our
plan upon pressing the login button the
code is going to end up in here saying
that the user's email is not verified
and it's going to remove the login route
from
from the stack and push the verify email
route on the screen okay so both
and that is exactly what we're getting
here you can see we're going to the
verify email view as we planned
okay as i mentioned this chapter was a
short one and that's actually really
good so what we need to do now is to
focus on what we're gonna do in the next
chapter as you can see it says our
authentication logic is all over the ui
and we need to make a service for the
authentication you see
up until this point we've been working
with firebase directly in the source
code in that we've been like writing
firebase auth code pretty much in our ui
now you may think that well that's okay
i mean
if you're if you don't come from a
software development background you may
think that that is fine and it should as
long as it works
but
the software development industry has
shown us over and over again that the
saying of oh if it if it's working if
it's not broken don't fix it that that
doesn't that doesn't really apply to all
cases as we've seen uh in the case of
for instance log 4j uh it was working
but then there was a security flying and
everybody had to go out to their code
base and fix everything so we're
entirely still of the weekends so the
code works
but there's a problem with it in that
here you have your user interface so the
code is quite high level it's like
literally the user is here and then we
have our user interface here and then we
have like the code that we've written
and like a little bit more low level
like our if statements and then firebase
is sitting all the way down here and
we're like exposing this firebase layer
all the way to our ui layers the ui is
talking directly with a layer of the
code that is so level that they
shouldn't have direct connection with
each other so
if you're not from a software
development background this may be a
little bit alien to you but software
developers really like to make sure
things are
com
liking their own compartments
so
what we need to do is in order to get
ready for the next chapter is just get a
good cup of coffee or tea because the
next chapter is actually going to be a
long one and it's going to be a
complicated one but i'm gonna do my best
to explain all the concepts as good as i
can but just know that the next chapter
is gonna be a
big one okay
so uh grab your refreshments juice tea
water coffee whatever you want and i'll
see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 24 of this
flutter course in the previous chapter
we talked about ensuring that the user's
email is verified before he or she can
proceed with the
with
by before the user is able to go to the
main ui of the application
um and what we are going to do now is
take a step back from developing our ui
and logic of the application by creating
an auth service
so
i'm going to provide you with a caption
here and as you can see it says auth
provider auth service meaning an author
provide abstract class on an off service
now
if we have a look at the code that we've
created so far let me bring up visual
studio code so you can see it on the
screen like i do here um i'm going to
increase the size so you see better
and i'm going to bring up the
application as well
so we can see it side by side
i have three screens here so it's a lot
it's a little bit difficult to juggle
um
excuse me
so i'm going to change the screen layout
so you see the code better
if you look here
we have our
um
three views login
register and verify email view okay
or we actually have four views the other
one is the main ui of the application
um which we have right now created in
here notes view
excuse me
but if you have a look at the login view
you can see one of the things that we're
doing immediately as we go to the login
view is
um
is not actually immediately by pressing
the login button we're talking with
firebase off signing in we are kind of
doing the same thing talking with
firebase by uh in the register view you
can see firebase auth instance create
user
and we also have firebase in our verify
email
so you can see here we are actually
importing firebase auth firebase so
if you're not uh like if you don't have
a software development background from
from before you may think well this is
this is fine very important firebase but
you also need to know that firebase is
kind of like a low-level abstraction
layer that um
that is talking to the firebase backend
and providing you with a lot of
high-level uh
functionality but those high-level
functionalities at the firebase level
they're kind of high level but if you
think about
that firebase is
a dependency that we're bringing into
our application that's talking with
firebase back-end in itself is
low-level compared with our ui so if you
think that
the ui code is here then what we are
doing is that we're like saying here is
firebase and then the ui is talking
directly with the firebase libraries and
functionalities and
in the in the eyes of a like a software
developer has been doing this for a
while this is not a good idea simply
because we're missing a little bit of a
layer in between the ui and firebase
which abstracts away the firebase
functionality from the ui of the
application
and as we talked about it before um it
is possible that in the future you may
want to allow for instance apple login
or google login or sign in with facebook
etc various options for signing in and
if you look at um the console at
firebase you'll see immediately that
you have various ways of authenticating
a user at the moment we've enabled sign
in method for email and password but you
also have the ability to add a new
provider you can as you can see google
facebook and these as you can see
they're called providers a new provider
and that is what we're going to do in
this chapter of our flashlight course as
well so
we're going to take firebase and
think of it as an authentication
provider okay so we're going to create a
class
which i believe we're calling at the
moment firebase auth provider
but we're gonna say that this firebase
auth provider comes from another class
which is called auth provider so what
we're gonna do then is gonna say okay
any auth provider that needs to that our
application can work with is expected to
have certain functionalities
and certain properties okay such as the
current auth provider should be able to
return the current user the author
provider should be able to log a user in
um
log user out register users send an
email verification so these
few basic functionalities
so that will be our abstract offs
provider class and then we will create
another class which is as we call it it
will be the concrete implementation of
that abstract class so think of the
abstract class as kind of like a
as it's it is our um contract
so we're saying any authentication
provider such as google facebook etc
will need to conform to the
functionality that we specified in this
abstract class okay
then we will go and develop a concrete
implementation of that abstract class
and we will call it firebase auth
provider and we will actually place the
real implementation of our
authentication
for firebase such as creating a user
logging user in etc etc in that concrete
implementation okay
and then what we will do also we will
create another class which we will call
it i believe we call it off service
and its goal
and in this course it won't do so much
what it will do it will just
take a provider such as a firebase auth
provider a google auth provider and it
will just expose the functionalities of
that provider to the outside world and
and the goal of this is that so we will
have our ui talking
with that service and that service will
talk to a provider which which is the
firebase auth provider and that firebase
auth provider will talk to firebase so
we're
right now we have firebase ui
but after after the end of this chapter
we will have firebase
um firebase auth provider
auth service and then the ui so we will
have two layers sitting in in between
and you may actually correctly think
that well this is a lot of work why do
we need that but
for me i if i wanted this course to be
just another course where i show you how
to include firebase then it wouldn't be
to be honest with you worth actually
doing yet another course about firebase
and flutter because there are lots of
courses available maybe not maybe not
courses that go through so much details
as i am going but i still believe that
my job here is not just to make you a
developer but also make you a good
developer where you take some extra
steps in order to make your code a
little bit better and this is why you
will actually notice as as you get more
into software development and working
with others in inside teams which you
may not be doing at the moment but when
you get your first job a software
developer you'll understand that other
software developers are actually taking
some extra steps in order to make their
code a little bit easier and better to
maintain so that's what we're gonna do
in our code okay
so um
that was
uh the intro for this chapter what we
need to do is to
um first think about how we're handling
our um exceptions
if you look inside the i mean in the
verify view we're not taking care of
exceptions as such maybe that's
something we'll need to do as well
but if you look at the login screen for
instance we're having here a try block
and then when it gets to firebase off
exception we're handling user not found
wrong password and then if anything else
happens we just say show error
so here there are two
specific errors off errors that we're
handling wrong password and the user not
found and if we go to
the register view you will also see we
have weak password email already used
and invalid email all right
so these are some of the exceptions that
we'll need to handle in our um in our
application but right now as you can see
our ui is going directly to firebase
auth exception and it's like importing
firebase auth exception which is
created inside let's have a look
firebase off accession src interface
it's in um
it's in one of the files which i believe
is accessible through firebase auth so
if you go to firebase off
that probably imports all the exceptions
as well there we go here it is
so
so our ui shouldn't really know anything
about firebase off by the end of this
chapter so let's take the first step
here then and let's go and create our
as you can see a new file
under lib
under folder called services auth and
then off
exceptions.dart so i'm gonna do that
right now
i'm going to collapse these and let's go
under lay down you can see that we don't
have con right now we have constants
utilities and views so we don't have
anything called services so let me right
click on lib and say new file and you
can do the same thing
and in here just enter the entire path
so say services
off and then we say off
exceptions.dart
okay
[Music]
oh that is our new file that we created
in there
and what we need to do is to go and
define all those exceptions so let's
begin by saying that we need a new
exception called user not found off
exception and if you remember user not
found is something that we're handling
here do you remember
firebase off exception in the login view
and if we cannot find that user we're
just showing an error saying show error
dialog so let's define an exception for
that and i'm going to say class
user not found and off
and i'm going to say implements
exception so this is a typical way of
creating exception classes in your in
your application that you say
and here is
my own class that is that for instance
represents an exception and it's it's
good practice just to say that it
implements an existing exception
exception you can see here by command
pressing on it you can see it goes to
flutter bin cache core exception start
so it is already imported by default you
don't have to import any specific file
in order to get access to the exception
class
so it's it suffices that you just
implement that class okay
so now let's go ahead and implement the
next
exception as the title as the caption
says here wrong password off exception
and that is also handled inside our
login view
wrong password right here
so
i'm just gonna go and kind of like copy
that code and in here i'm just gonna say
wrong password
auth exception
all right what else are we handling here
nothing else in the login view at least
so that's that's really good so
i'm just going to close the login view
for now
and save this file okay
so let's now start taking care of some
of the exceptions that we're handling in
our register view and let's go to
register view and you'll see here that
the first section exception that we're
handling is called weak password
so
i'm going to put a comment in here and
a comment in here i'm going to say login
exceptions
and and register
exceptions okay
so as the caption says let's create a
class called weak password auth
exception gonna copy this code from here
and i'm gonna say weak
password off exception
so that's for the register views weak
password the next one is email already
in use so that's what the caption says
here as well so let's go and copy this
and i'm gonna say email already in use
auth exception
okay
so now we have the password and email
already and use exceptions
and let's have a look
and we also have the invalid email
auth exception
which i don't think i had planned for
but let's go and implement that as well
so let's say invalid email
author okay
okay um
now what we also need to do is to
define a few
other exceptions as you remember from
register view
we also have the case of an else where
we basically say something else happened
here it's an off exception but something
else may have happened that we haven't
handled with this code or we may also
have another cat statement here that
catches like generic exceptions and
we're we're doing the same thing as you
can see the code here um and let me
change the screen layout so you see it
better i'm gonna go to
the login view as well because we're
doing the exact same thing in the login
view in that
upon getting a firebase auth exception
this code
then we also have an else statement even
in there so we're saying if the code is
not like handled by us it may be another
code in that case also show the show
error dialog or in that case show error
dialogue
and we're also doing a catch like a
generic catch as well so we need kind of
like an
exception that handles all those cases
so
an unknown code during the firebase off
exception and an unknown exception so
we're gonna create a generic exception
all right
i'm gonna change the screen layout a
little bit
um like that i'm gonna go to my notes
okay
so let's just in here say generic
exceptions
um and i'm gonna
bring
this one up as well
today i'm gonna bring this one first so
let's go ahead and create a generic auth
exception i'm gonna copy this code from
here i'm going to say generic auth
exception
okay
and what we also need to do is to
provide
this thing user not logged in
off exception
and you will you will know now that
um
i mean you will need to know why we're
actually having a use or not logged in
off exception and
this will be an exception that our um
that our firebase provider will be able
to throw
if
the user is null
after registering that user for instance
so let's say that we tell our auth
provider we say register a user with
this email and password and no exception
happens nothing
so we the application thinks that all
right everything went as expected but
what if the user
that we access
at firebase auth
is null in that case our auth provider
should be able to handle that and send
an exception saying that oh i couldn't
find this user or this user isn't logged
in so let's create that exception as
well so i'm just going to say
user not logged in exception so let's
just say class
implement
exception
okay so user not logged in off exception
and i'm gonna save that as well
all right that was a lot of work now we
have created all those files oh sorry
maybe you didn't actually see the code
that i wrote i don't like having
captions up all the time but i also
think captions are so important so that
you always know what we're working with
but the downside of having these
captions at the bottom left of the
screen is that sometimes they hide what
i'm typing so i'm doing my best really
to
catch those and
catch that issue and if i see that
happening i'll i'm gonna bring the
screen up like this so you see it but
sometimes i may be missing that i
apologize for that so let's let's say
that and now we've implemented all our
exceptions
and as you can see in the captions it
says we need an auth user we shouldn't
expose firebase's user to the ui
and this to be honest with you is the
same story as we had for our exceptions
the ui code should not at all be working
with firebase the ui code should be so
high level and so abstracted from the
rest of your application that it
shouldn't even at all know how it is
functioning you're just giving it
different
providers and services and it should be
calling those services and providers not
really knowing how they're tied together
and at the moment you can see our login
view it's like
where let's go in here
you can see here in login view and for
me it's on line 67 for you maybe in a
different line but we're after calling
the sign in with email and password
function which we also shouldn't be
doing
but
what we're doing after that is we're
getting the current user from firebase
and this user is of type you can see
let's go in here and see it's of type
user so if i go put the type in here and
command click on it you'll see this user
is part of firebase auth you see there's
a fun there's a class called user so
we are all we were also like exposing a
firebase user to our ui and that is not
a good idea
so as a caption says here we shouldn't
expose firebase's user to the ui so we
need to have our own user that abstracts
away the functionality
or that that the current user at
firebase level has okay
so
let's go ahead and do that so
we're going to create an off user dart
file in lib services auth a file called
off
user so i'm going to remove or sorry i'm
going to close all the files that i've
created and under
services auth i'm going to then create
an off user
so i'm going to say off user.dark
and in this off user then we need to
basically start working with firebase in
this case so i'm going to go to my notes
just to ensure i'm telling you
everything that i'm um that i plan to
tell you
all right so let's go in here and import
firebase
it's user import package
and is it in
firebase auth i believe and then we're
gonna say show user okay and as i've
mentioned before this is a great way of
just ensuring that you're not exposing
too much of a packages classes to your
current workspace except what you're
saying is that firebase auth is isn't it
maybe an entire dart file with its
structures maybe thousands of classes
now i'm exaggerating but a lot of
classes but you are only interested in
the user class okay
so
you could also like say
as
firebase
off like that and then you would say
show user and that will allow you so if
i say test
then you will be able to say
firebaseauth.user
you can also do that if you if you
prefer to for instance ha prefix the
user in this case that comes from
firebase with the actual place that it
comes from you could also use as
some people may like it and i also do
but i haven't planned to do that in in
this particular
file so do it if you want to the way
that i'm doing it here so you can follow
along with the steps that i'm providing
for you in this course without diverging
from
from the point
okay now that we've done the um
import
what we need to do as a caption in the
case we need to create the actual class
so let's say class off user
and in here what we need is a field
called is email verified now remember
right now all we need from our off user
is to know whether that email is
verified or not so if you go for
instance to our login view
you can see that we have this code here
and
that signs a user in with email and
password and right after that gets the
user and all it does with that user says
email verified
and we're doing the same thing in
register view i believe so let's go to
register view and you can see in here
and it says
actually there we're not doing anything
with the email verified all we're doing
is just saying a send email verification
so sorry about that so it's in login
screen okay so let's go in our off user
in here and say it has a property called
is email verified okay so
i'm gonna say final and bull is email
and you saw that firebase has
implemented this function this uh
property as email verified i personally
prefer to call boolean functions boolean
getters in this case like a property of
a class with is wherever i see that fit
it's just because it makes a lot more
sense for me at least to say user dot is
email verified rather than saying
user.email verified
it just makes it more like complete
grammatically is blah blah verified or
is that
so that's the reason that we're
diverging a little bit
okay um
now you see this in here and we're
saying it's email verified you can get
help from visual studio code to
create a constructor for final fields
and even if you don't want to do that
you could always just type it by hand
you can say off user self is email
verified sorry this is email verified
and since this class it only has a
property that you can set upon
initialization and you're not changing
it because it's a final field
excuse me
you can make your constructor a const
excuse me again and it would also be
good if you could
basically let's say
immutable as another try defining
undefined i believe you actually have to
import foundation in here
now immutable basically is
but immutable here i don't think we've
talked about that before but it's just
like an annotation telling that this
class and any subclasses of this class
are going to be immutable meaning that
their internals are never going to be
changed upon initialization so if you
then go and create for instance class my
off user and say extends the auth user
and then you'll have a bull
um let's say in here and you create a
constructor for it so let's create a
constructor for it so boom okay
prefer declaring what is a const okay
then we say const then you say okay well
i want a boolean flag in here bull is
blah
and
um
yeah
bull is blocked
now you see it says null not
non-nullable instance flab but it must
be initialized let's just initialize it
to false and and it says can't define a
cons constructor okay then we're not
going to make it a cons constructor and
now you see that little warning here it
says this class or a class that this
class inherits from is marked as
immutable but one or more of its
instance feels aren't final so
now you see what immutable means it
tells dart that this class and all its
subclasses need to be immune immutable
they cannot have any fields that change
so by removing this field then you get
rid of that
little warning and you can make this
cons and the error completely goes away
so now you know what immutable means
okay
all right great now we created that is
email verified at a cons constructor for
our off user
let's go to the next point
the next point as you can see here it
says we need a factory constructor
that creates our
auth user from a firebase user and
factory constructors are really useful
for this purpose in that you have
let's say object x and you want to
create an object y from that instead of
you manually gluing things in some sort
of a middle layer saying now i take the
object x and add some blah blah and fuse
it together and then put object y you
can put that responsibility on object y
and saying that you need to be able to
initialize yourself or construct an
instance of yourself from this object
and this is like a typical pattern that
you'll see everywhere so
um well everywhere everywhere but where
you have the ability to do that so
that's what we're gonna do now with a
factory constructor so let's say we have
a factory constructor here
we'll say off user and we say from
firebase okay as the caption says then
we take a firebase user in here
like that and then we say what we will
do in here we will actually create an
instance of our own class an off user
given that user okay so let's say that
we create
an off user in here
and a lot of user and it's email
verified comes from user email verified
like that
all right so this shouldn't be they
shouldn't be that difficult to
understand so this creates
this goes into
this constructor you can see
and it takes the email verified value of
the firebase user and places it in this
class so all we did is just we kind of
like copied
a firebase user and
we
made a copy of it into our own off user
okay so we're not
exposing firebase's user and all of its
properties to our user interface
all right that was a lot of information
now let's talk about an auth provider as
i mentioned in the beginning of this
chapter
and as you saw in the firebase console
you will have the possibility to add
various auth providers to your
application when you're working with
firebase so such as
google and apple facebook
and many many more okay an email and
password combination like we're doing so
all of those are providers
what we need to do now is to create an
alt provider class that encapsulates
every provider that we may add in the
future and creates a nice interface for
them says every provider that our
application can work with should conform
to this particular interface okay
so let's go ahead and take care of that
now and i can see here we're going to
create that file on the lib services
auth
off provider so we have lib services off
but we don't have auth provider files so
let's let's right click on auth and say
off provider dart
and go to my notes
so
what we're going to do in here then is
since our off uh provider
is going to work with our
um
it's for instance
the the functions that we're going to
provide for our auth provider are for
instance a getter that gets the current
user so that's not a function it's just
a getter the way we're actually doing it
in here if you see let me go to login
view
and you'll see in login view here this
thing at the moment say firebase auth
instance current user this is a getter
so this is a property and returns the
firebase user what we want is for our
auth provider to also be able to provide
us with the current user now remember
we've abstracted away the firebase user
with our own auth user which we just
created okay so what we need is this
abstract class that can return an
instance of our off user okay
so for that we need to import this off
user into this dart file so let's just
say import
package
this application that i've created as
you can see in the title it's called my
notes
so let's go to my notes services
auth and then auth user so that's the
import statement as you can see in the
caption i've written package xxx and
that's where you need to put the name of
your package in this case for me is my
notes
all right that's great now let's go and
create an abstract class so i've
mentioned this twice before but our auth
provider dart file is not gonna have
really
is not gonna have any logic it's an
abstract class though abstract classes
in dart can contain logic but in this
case our abstract class is just going to
be a protocol or you may know it as
interface or you may also know it as
well an abstract class so let's go ahead
and create that let's say abstract class
auth provider
and so the abstract class creation is
done what we need to do is now give it
like the ability to return the current
off user okay so as the caption says
we're going to say off user and get
current user okay
so we're saying any author provider
whether it works with email password
whether it's a google auth provider
whether it's an apple facebook twitter
whatever it needs to be able to
optionally return the current currently
authenticated user and that's what this
optional site is
here for okay
and then what we will also need to do is
to
allow it to
be able to log a user in okay so we're
going to say we will have a function
that
completes in the future
and returns an off user
and it says log in
like this okay
and now we have to think what does this
login actually require well in our case
it requires email and password so let's
just put email and password we're
thinking that every author provider that
we're writing is going to have an email
and password combination of some sort
you could say id and password but i'm
just going to go with email and password
for now okay so let's make these
required parameters as well so i'm going
to put curly brackets here and curly
bracket here i'm going to say required
stream email
and then a required stream password like
this
okay
and a semicolon at the end of that
command s to save the file so dark
formatter can do its magic
and the reason where you see if we go to
author sorry if you go to our login
screen again
and in here we say sign in with user and
password you can see that it always
returns a user credential now you may
you may think how can i always return a
user credential if the current email and
password are actually incorrect and they
don't belong to a valid user well the
way that firebase is handling is that if
you say sign in with email and password
if you can grab the current user if he
can't sign in that user with the
information that you provide it returns
it otherwise it fails with an exception
meaning that it's saying that as long as
you call me and there's no exception i
will give you user credential if there
is an exception well you need to handle
that so that is a great way to avoid
having functions let me close the off
user as well avoid having functions that
do like this that option on your return
user so
do your work in your functions
return the user and return the object
that you promised if you can't do that
throw an error so you don't have to do
this do this kind of a optional return
okay
for a the login function now we need to
also have a function that can create a
user so that imagine that it's for the
sign up or
um
yeah what else do we call it uh register
yeah so
let's call it a create user so we say
this also returns a auth user
and we call it creates user like this
and this also has all these parameters
so i'm just going to copy and paste this
you don't have to do that twice and a
semicolon at the end
all right guard formatter do its thing
and then let's go and
and create a function that allows us
then to log a user out because that's
what we're doing in the main ui of the
application okay
the log out it's not going to return any
value as you can see in the caption here
just a future void so we say future void
log out just like that
all right so that was simple
and also we will need a function that
can send an email verification okay so
this one's also very easy it's just a
future void and as you can see in
captions we're calling it send email
verification all right
so
how was that
okay
as i mentioned
our office provider at the moment is
just an abstract class so
it's
dictating an interface for any
authentication provider that we're gonna
add to our application
we but just so you know we are only
going to add an email author provider
okay
or
sorry a firebase author provider
but this way by creating an abstract
class with an author provider as a name
and then you create a concrete class
called firebase auth provider you're
able to in the future to extend this and
add more and more auth providers all of
which will follow the same interface
okay so that's the goal
but we're only in this in this course
are gonna use firebase auth provider
so uh just so you know
as the caption says go ahead and create
a a file called firebase auth provider
in your services auth folder i'm gonna
right click here and i'm gonna say oops
uh and say new file i'm gonna call it
firebase off
dot provider.net
now let's go in here and say
um i'm gonna go to my notes a little bit
here uh
like that okay so this is gonna be like
the juiciest part of um
of this chapter we are actually going to
abstract the way firebase authentication
into our own provider so expect this
file to grow a little bit in size i can
see my notes it's going to go to about
100 lines of code but that's okay too so
and um we can just get started with it
and so
as you can see in the caption we need to
import a few of files auth user
auth provider and off exceptions we need
auth user because this sorry actually
let me first
explain why we need to import auth
provider because our firebase auth
provider is going to be a concrete
implementation of the file auth provider
or the class auth provider that we just
created so that's the reason for that
import
the os user import is going to be
because as you can see in the auth
provider
the login and create user functions they
need to return an off user so that's why
we need to import off users so that our
provider can return instances of that
okay
and last but not least we also need to
import auth exceptions because remember
our firebase auth provider is also going
to
abstract away all the authentication
errors and exceptions that otherwise
happen at the firebase level into our
own exceptions that we've created
here off exceptions okay so let me go
ahead and first import off user so
package
and this application called my notes
and we have services auth
and then we have
off user okay so i'm gonna import that
and i'm gonna copy this file then and
this line and the next one is gonna be
the off provider
and as you can see in the captures we
also have to import auth exceptions
so those are the three imports
now
since we have our own imports
and this file is going to talk directly
with firebase we also need to import
firebase of course so and let's go ahead
and import
and i'm going to actually copy that code
so i don't have to type all of it
because it's a little bit boring but you
can see
in the captions at least what you need
to import the firebase off and you need
to also import firebase off exception
okay
great
so that's our imports
um now what we need to do is to create
the actual class and
um as you can see it's going to be
called firebase all provider and
implements auth provider which is our
own class so let's say firebase
auth provider implements
a provider just like that okay and now
you can see you get an error same
missing concrete implementation i'm
going to change the layout of the screen
so you see the code in its entirety
and then what we need to do is to
implement you see those function
functions and getters that auth provider
abstract class
says that every class that implements it
needs to implement those things as well
so you may try to do those things by
hand but i absolutely
i i i'm not at all a fan of doing things
by hand sorry about that so i prefer to
get help from the editor to complete
these things so i'm just going to say
command dot
and make class firebase off abstract
create five missing overrides okay so
there we go so visual studio code
created all those functions in here and
you can see in all of them it just says
throw unimplemented error
great stuff
i'm gonna decrease the size of the font
here go back to the
same layout that we had before
so the first thing that we need to do in
here let's go ahead and implement this
current user okay
so this is going to have a lot of
not a lot but it's going to have a bit
of logic so i'm going to do this instead
of being with a pointer
and let's go ahead in here and try to
get that user so let's say
you see our job is now to get the
firebase user and turn it into an off
user remember our off user had a factory
constructor so we need to call that
factory constructor okay so let's just
say final user is equal to firebase off
our firebase
and auth
instance
and then we say current user
and then we say if user is not null
and we need to create an instance of it
as off users so we just say return
off user from firebase user okay
otherwise we return null like this so
if firebase says there's a user then we
create an off user out of that and we
just return it
okay that was for a current user it
wasn't so much of code to be honest with
you
now what we need to do is to take care
of create user which is this function
right here
so create user is going to be a little
bit thicker to be honest so
let's go ahead and
first do a little bit of formatting in
here so i like to always
append a comma at the end of the last
parameter of my function so that when i
do dark formatter
or dart format it's going to break all
these parameters into their own
lines okay because before it looked like
this and it's not so clean in my eyes at
least it's a preference thing
okay so
in here what we need to do is to
create basically uh
a user with uh firebase
so i'm going to put this entire thing in
in a try block and then we're going to
catch firebase off exception
and
on firebase off exception catch e okay
so just like that
and then we're going to have a generic
cache block in here
like this
all right uh now what we need to do in
create user in the tri-state main
statement we need to actually tell
firebase that we want to create a new
user so let's say firebase
off
instant and then we say create user with
email and password okay so we have the
email here and the password and we can
see those parameters already there so we
don't have to do anything
so
um but what we need to do here is you
can first actually see yeah this
function needs to return a value we're
gonna fix this so don't worry about that
but we also need to await on this
because remember creating a user or
email password is not a function that
just returns immediately and this is one
of the things that is absolutely
beautiful about dart in that in the
interface we didn't actually say that
this function has to be async but you
can in this concrete implementation make
this function async so it's absolutely
beautiful so async is not the part of
the signature of the function but it has
more to do with the internals of that
function so in order to call this
function with an await you see if we put
a weight here we get an error we need to
make this function async all right so
great stuff
all right so after doing that what we're
going to do is to get the current user
if the current user is there then we're
just gonna return the current user if
the current user after creating a user
or email and password and no exceptions
is not there then that is a bad sign and
we need to return then one of our auth
exceptions called user not logged in off
exception okay
so i'm going to close this so let's go
in here and say final
user is
get or just user is the current user
remember we already have a getter for a
current user right here
okay
and it just gets the current user from
firebase so we say here's the user
if the user is available there
is not null
then just return the user
otherwise you should throw a user not
found or i think that's what we call the
user not logged in
auth exception all right
that's for the creation of the user if
everything goes fine except for this
part
now we need to go to our firebase auth
exception and we need to handle a few
things um
so if you look at where in our register
view
in here we are handling weak password
email already in use and invalid email
so let's just copy these three things
okay actually these four things because
we have an else block in there as well
okay
so i'm gonna copy that code just do the
same thing please so go to your registry
and copy that code go back to your
firebase auth provider inside the
firebase off exception where you're
catching that
paste that code but remove everything
that has anything to do with the show
error dialog okay so at least we have
if and else statements okay
like this so you should end up with a
code that looks like this
now
where there is a weak password we are
actually going to throw our own error so
we're going to say throw
weak password off exception
it is an email already in use we're
going to throw email already and use
authexception
in case on invalid email throw invalid
email off exception and if there is any
other code that we don't know about
we're just going to throw a generic auth
exception
and also if there is a final catch
basically meaning that by calling the
create user an email with email and
password if there is any other exception
other than firebase auth exception we
also need to handle that and throw
a generic auth exception there as well
okay
a lot of code but
hopefully this makes our ui code
easier to read okay so we're doing this
for a good purpose
great stuff that's for
our
create user i'm gonna fall create user
uh if it allows me to fold the entire
create user poof and i'm gonna fold
current user as well so this is a
technique that you can or not a
technique that's just a trick you can do
in your editor if it supports folding
and unfolding just to make sure that it
looks a little bit cleaner okay because
now that you've written create user you
may not be directly interested in all
its details you may just want to know
that it's there okay
all right the next thing we need to do
is to implement send email verification
so let's find that function and i can
see it's right here send email
verification i'm gonna scroll a little
bit up so you see
like that
i'm gonna go to my notes as well okay
so what we need to do then is to
incent email verification what we need
is to also mark this as async because
it's going to call an asynchronous
function on firebase as well okay
and we need to
call the send email verification
function on the firebase user remember
our user doesn't have that functionality
our user only has is email verified
property so in here let's get the
firebase user so i'm going to say user
is firebase
off
instance current user
and we say
if user is not null then we call that
function so we say await user send email
verification i remember i think this was
the future of void so that's why we're
doing a weight on it and that is why we
have the async tag in here okay now
if the user is nil then we're gonna just
say user is not logged in you cannot
send an email verification from user
who's not logged in okay so then you
throw user not
logged in off exception
okay
so that's our send email verification
function
let's then fold this function as well so
we don't see its internals
as the caption says now we need to go
and implement a login login is just as
important as creating a user i'm going
to start by putting a comma at the end
of password parameter here and command s
in order to save it
and in here in the login function we're
going to do something very similar to
what we're doing in the register
function i can see in my notes
by doing a try
and then we say on firebase off
exception
and catch
e
and then we'll say
catch
any other exception okay so
let's in in here then start by um
telling firebase that we want to log in
with those credentials so let's say
firebase auth instance and then we say
uh
sign in with email and password so
there's a function in there okay
and i'm gonna put a
semicolon at the end so you can see the
code
all right so that's what we're doing but
remember again these functions are
asynchronous so you can't just call that
function and expect it to work it's a
future of user credential okay so make
your function asynchronous and then
await on this
function so we're going to do something
very similar similar to what we're doing
in register sorry in the create user in
in that we're saying final user is
current user
i hope you can see that code yes i can
see that you can see so in this in this
uh code we're gonna take the exact same
code that we wrote in um
create user so i'm gonna expand that you
can see here
i'm gonna copy that code and you could
do the same what we're doing is just
making sure after signing in then there
is a current user okay copy that code
gonna fold this then i'm gonna bring it
to the login and right after sign in
with email and password i'm gonna paste
that code okay so that's that part
now
you see now we have firebase
authexception again to handle just like
we did with create so let's go to your
um login view
and have a look at which
and which exceptions we were handling so
i can see here we're handling these
i'm actually going to copy that entire
code from login view you see a firebase
off exception username wrong password
etc and including the catch any other
exception block right here copy that
code and bring it to your
firebase auth provider
and
replace let me actually see how it looks
like
yeah replace all of this with that okay
and then remove your weights as we did
before to be honest with you this this
is just a lot of big talk for saying
that we
um
need some code from another place to
bring here so your code now should look
like this so it says on firebase off
exception and we're handling user not
found wrong password off exceptions from
firebase and a generic catch block okay
so in the case of a user not found a
firebase office session we're going to
say throw user not found alt exception
in the case of a wrong password we're
going to say throw on password boss
exception
and any other case that might occur here
we're just going to throw generic off
exception
and in here as well we're going to say
throw generic with exception
and
thing i really like to do is you see in
dart it's not yet possible to say that i
want to ignore a variable in this case
you can see that in this like where we
have a catch
we actually have to pattern match
against an exception and then we have to
assign a name to it and that name is
called e inside this function so if i
type e you can see it's an object
however as you can see in the body of
this function we're not actually
interested in e at all we're not using
it so in in other languages it is
possible to ignore like in javascript
python swift rust it is possible to
ignore a variable and saying that hey
i'm not interested in this value by
putting something called like an
underscore or something you can do the
same thing in art the difference is that
in dart if you say underscore you're not
actually ignoring it that variable is
also there but it's just called
underscore in this case so you can see
you can still call to string on it so
you may want to do it or you may just
want to leave it alone because you can
see guard an analyzer it doesn't give
you an error
of any kind saying that yeah your
pattern matching but you're not using it
so it's up to you how you want to do it
and i like to do it like this
wow that was a lot of code um or maybe
more like a lot of explanations so let's
go to login and fold that and as you can
see in the caption now we have to take
care of the logout function and
the caption also says that this function
needs to be asynchronous okay
and you know why because we're going to
call a function on firebase in order to
take care of the logouts
so in order for a user to be logged out
the user should actually exist so let's
just say final
user needs firebase off
instance
and then we're going to say current user
and we say if user is not null
and it's a user sign uh logout what's it
called or what's it called
oh we have to tell a firebase off so we
then we say firebase
off instance sign out
the weight on it okay
otherwise we say throw user not
logged in
so we're basically saying here that you
cannot log out a user if that user
doesn't exist okay or that user isn't
logged in
all right
lots of code lots of description but
that's okay we've now implemented an
auth provider firebase auth provider
okay
which is a concrete implementation of
auth provider
now as the caption indicates here we
need an auth service
um now what is an auth service i
mentioned this a little bit before but
an auth service is also going to
implement auth provider
and
in itself is going to take an instance
of an auth provider as well
but as you'll see in this chapter and in
the rest of this um
course you'll see that our
our auth service is really just the
provider itself which is
exposing all the functionalities of the
provider that we give it
and it's not and it has absolutely no
other logic at the moment okay but the
reason we're doing that is for me to
just to show you that you need to have
providers and then you need to have
services that they talk to each other
and then this service can then expose
more value to your user interface to
your ui code than the provider does
that's usually the case that the service
fuses together
a few other providers talk to few
providers and at the end it grabs the
data fuses together and provides that
information to the ui now in our case
that's not gonna be the case okay our
firebit our auth service is only going
to talk with our the given auth provider
and expose all its functionalities to
the ui but we're doing this exercise so
that you see how you can abstract away
various bits and pieces of functionality
from the ui code so remember that that's
the reason we have our auth service
which we're gonna soon create okay
so as a caption in the case here let's
go ahead and create our odd service
inside the auth folder here so auth and
i'm going to create a new file here i'm
just going to call it all service
in this dart file then we need to create
start creating our
auth service okay
sorry gonna go to my notes in here as
well so
what we need in here is to
import a few things we need to import
our auth provider and an off user so i'm
not to explain this again so um package
my notes
and we have services off
and we have and we need to import auth
provider
and copy this kind of code and then i'm
going to say off news user i believe
so
um
so let's have a look in here in the
captions
like that
okay so we need to create now as you can
see we need to create an auth service
that also implements auth provider okay
so
um
if i look at the captions here why is
auth service an author provider i've
already explained this to you but you
can see it says but can have more logic
so that's the reason okay so don't
forget that so let's go and create a
class of all service in here
and it implements an off of the auth
provider
um abstract class okay
now what you'll need to do what you need
to know is that the auth service in
itself isn't going to be hard coded to
use the firebase auth provider
what it's going to do is that it's going
to actually take an audit provider from
you
and saying that okay i will then expose
the functionalities from that auth
provider to the outside world with the
ability to maybe even change that data
before it returns it to you but in our
chapter and then the rest of this course
it's not going to do that it's just
going to expose the same auth providers
functionality to the outside world so
let's go ahead and as the caption says
say we take an auth provider and we just
call it provider okay
we need to do then is to create a
constructor
for your auth servicing here so command
dot on mac or control dot windows and
linux and say create constructor for
final fields and make it constant as
well
okay so now we have this beautiful
little off service that takes the
provider but as you can see it says
missing concrete implementations and
that's because we said our auth service
is also an auth provider so we have to
implement those auth provider classes
overrides as well so let's add them in
here as well but this time it's gonna be
a lot easier uh to implement these
functions because our because our auth
service internally has a provider and
all it has to do is just
expose the functionalities of the
provider in its own
implementation all right
so
um
as the caption also says we need to
delegate then to our
actual provider
before we do that i'm going to do a
little bit of a clean up here and i
suggest that you do too and in places
that we have more than one parameter
let's go and put a comma at the end of
the last parameter right here and there
boom
and
that was it i'm going to do command s so
that dart formatter formats the code a
little bit better
and let's just go and go ahead and
expose the functionalities of our
provider in our
concrete implementations of the auth
provider so in here we say provider dot
creates user email and password perfect
for the current user we return the
provider's current user we say provider
adopt current user
for the login we then expose the
providers login function we say provider
login with that information
and for our logout we do the same thing
so i'm going to say provider logout okay
and for sending you
so say provider send email
provider
and notification great stuff that was uh
that went really fast as you can see
okay
now
um
you see we've done a lot of code now if
we go to our if if i change the screen
layout a little bit better a little bit
so you see the code better and let's go
to our terminal the built-in terminal i
absolutely love it in visual studio code
that there is an integrated terminal
and let's have a look at our git status
you'll see that we have changed login
view but also there is an entirely new
folder here called lib services so if
you then add all of that
and to get status you'll see that we
actually have done a lot of work so
if i increase the size you see we've
added all exceptions auth provider all
service auth user and firebase auth
provider
plus the changes in the login view
now
um actually i don't know what did we
change in login view
so
that's interesting to know if you go to
the login view did we
did we change anything in login view
because at the moment i can't really
remember if we change anything special
in the login view
so it would be interesting to actually
see what we've done so if i go to my
terminal here
and
if i issue this command as you can see
here i'm going to remove that
login view from the staging environment
so like this
paste it there
and i'm gonna say git status and then
i'm gonna say bit diff i can say okay
the difference is that i
have added firebase core in here
which i don't see
in the
login view and also
what's changed
has this navigator been removed
there's a lot of code in here that may
have not been committed from the
previous chapter that may be it so that
may be the reason okay but that's all
right as well so now let's get at all
and let's then go to the next stage as
you can see we've done a lot of work
let's just make sure everything is
committed this time okay so get status
everything is added to the staging
environment then i'm just gonna say git
commit
message and step eight this time
and i'm going to push all those changes
and get status i can see everything's
committed great
also let's tag our code because i
believe the previous
chapter we didn't tag anything but the
one before that we tagged that step
seven and that was chapter number 22
where we talked about error handling in
the registry and going to the next
screen after registration so we didn't
tag anything in the previous chapter so
now we're going to tag things as step 8
so let's just say git tag step 8
i can spell here
and it push tags as well
if you can say git log you will see get
step 8 is there step 7 every step is
there an initial commit is there as well
which is step one and if you say git tag
you'll see all your tags available as
well okay so
we've committed and tagged we've done a
lot of work in this chapter and i don't
think we need to actually drag it on for
longer because yeah it will be
unbearable maybe if it's too long
now
as we usually do which is the tradition
here before going to the next chapter we
prepare ourselves for what is coming as
you can see in the caches that we need
to migrate our existing code to using
our own auth service we have an auth
service
which abstracts away the provider and we
have a firebase auth provider but we
still are not using that code so that's
exactly what we're going to do in the
next chapter and if i look a little bit
in my in my notes i can actually see the
next chapter will also be quite a long
one maybe not as long as this chapter so
maybe you'll need a cup of coffee or tea
so
let's do that and without further ado
i'll see you in the next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 25
of this flutter course
in the previous chapter we talked about
earth service and that was quite a big
chapter we talked about cleaning up
making sure that our authentication
related code is in
one central place we created the auth
provider the firebase auth provider then
we created
our auth service
and and we also ensure that
both the service and the provider are
conforming to the interface provided by
our abstract class for authentication
so um we call those the off service and
the firebase auth provider and then our
abstract class was called auth provider
now we've done all that work but we
haven't really even started using that
auth service and that's what we're going
to do in this chapter
um
the first thing that we have to do is
actually
making sure that we have easy access to
our off service
um you see the way we created the auth
service let me
bring the code here so we can all see
change visual studio codes um
layouts a little bit
let's then have a look at our um let me
see if i can resize this a little bit as
well okay let's have a look here at our
auth service you see that with the way
that we created our off service is that
it in its initializer or constructor
however you want to call it um it is
taking a provider so for us to be able
to use our auth service every time you
want to use our auth service we actually
have to provide it with an auth provider
which in our case is going to be the
firebase auth provider which it resides
right here
so this could be cumbersome especially
if you're working with firebase quite a
lot in your user interface every time
you want to use it then you need to say
auth service initialize the auth service
and then initialize your firebase auth
provider and give that to your
auth service so
we don't want to do that every time
and that is exactly why we need to
create a
factory uh
initializer as you can see here in the
uh
in
the captions so uh it says add firebase
factory to officers and that's exactly
what we're gonna do here
so let's go to our auth service and as
the code is provided for you just write
it
factory and i'm going to say auth
service dot
in firebase so the responsibility of
this off service firebase factory here
or sorry the the responsibility of the
firebase uh
factory here
on our off service is to return an
instance of our auth service that is
already configured with a firebase auth
provider so
then we're going to say it returns an
instance of auth service
change the layout of the code here the
screen as well so you can see it better
and we're going to say firebase
um
auth provider okay
so that's that um now you see i have a
column here in visual studio code that
tells me where the code is going to
break some people even for one parameter
in their uh dart code or flutter code
they prefer to have a comma at the end
of it so that it is ready to take new
parameters in the future so if you do
that then um
dart format is going to break that code
for you into multiple lines ready for
you to enter the next parameter if
that's your preference go for it but i
have no preference here i just leave it
like that when i have one parameter i
just leave it in one line okay
so
before we actually go about uh starting
to use our auth service we need to take
a little trip back to the main dart file
as the caption indicates here so you
either go to the explorer but the way i
usually like to do it is with command p
and i say main dart and then i go there
remember if you are linux or windows
then you have to do control p okay so
let's have a look at our main dar file
and let's see if i can close these
places firebase off firebase provider
login the dart
what did we change there save that as
well let's go back to the main now so
basically i just closed all the files
uh because i just want to have them in
our files so as the caption is
is telling you here um our menu action
and the notes view are right now spread
just around in the main dart file and
this is usually not a good idea because
you need to as part of your journey into
becoming a software developer you need
to make sure that your code is clean and
it's easy for other people to read now
i'm not saying i mean i'm not a true
true believer that the code has to be so
easy to understand that even if you grab
a random person from the street they
have to understand the code because
sometimes you need to make sure that
the person looking at your code has a
certain level of knowledge from before
but with all that said you need to make
sure that your code is easy to
understand and read so
let's make sure that the menu action and
notes view are refactored and that
they're in the right place and not just
spread around in main dart file
so as a caption indicates we're going to
move our menu action into
a new new folder called enums inside lib
and the file name is going to be menu
action dot dart and
the caption was a little bit wrong it
shouldn't be dark 10 it should be dart
so i'm going to save the caption and
bring it back up so it's with the right
file extension
so let's go and create that file i'm
gonna go here into lib i'm gonna right
click on lib and i'm gonna say new file
and in the new file i'm just going to
type ins
and
bring it up as well so you see it better
or you see it at all enums and then menu
action. okay
excuse me
let's just go and grab that menu action
from there and paste it inside this menu
action and save that file okay don't
worry main.dart at the moment has a
problem because menu action doesn't
exist here anymore so we're getting some
errors and that's okay we're gonna fix
that
so let's go now to our um
to the main dark file again and we have
to clean up this notes view and as the
caption in the case we're going to move
it into
lib views notes view okay we already
have the views folder remember from
before all we're going to do is just to
move this notes view into its own file
so i'm going to right right click on
views and i'm going to say
notes view dot darts
okay let's go to main guard grab the
notes view and it's state so from there
notes view stateful widget and i'm gonna
grab all of that
and
we're gonna even
take the show log out dialog with it
and bring it
to note2 and paste that there okay so
now we have a lot of problems because uh
in an empty dart file as i've mentioned
before there's no material import so i'm
going to do the material import now so
command dot and say import library
package flower material and that is
going to fix those import
those errors for you
now this file doesn't have it hasn't
imported
uh menu action so let's fix that as well
with visual studio command dot and get
help from visual studio code to
automatically import our menu action
dart file okay
so that is also fixed and also remember
now in notes view also right now is
using firebase off and we're going to
fix somebody into this chapter so that
note2 isn't or any of our views none of
them are going to talk directly with
firebase so that's going to be fixed by
the end of this chapter
but for now let's go ahead and clean
this up and make sure that firebase auth
is imported and also remember login
route was used here when we log out of
the main interface of the application so
when we log out then it sends us back to
the login route and that is defined in
our routes
dart file here so let's import that too
excuse me
all right so that was a lot of work
we've we've done that now so we're done
so i'm going to save this notes view dot
dart
and
now as the the case we need to go back
to the main dart and remedy this issue
which we have and we need to import
notes view uh get help from visual
studio code or your favorite editor or
if you don't have this functionality in
your editor if you're using vim or
something you may just need to import
that by hand and the import is just the
package name of your application views
notes view okay so i'm gonna
get help from visual studio code to do
that
great
so
um
now let's have a look at something that
we actually forgot in the previous
chapters
um you see we've done everything in our
off service if you have a look at our
auth service it has almost all the
functionalities that we need it has
create view sorry create user it has
current user it has login log out and
send email verification but there's one
detail that we forgot about let's go to
main dart and have a look at it
you can see in here our entire main dart
uh
like the home page build function is
built around a future builder that i i
know i'm saying build quite a lot maybe
i should say it's revol it's revolving
around a future builder which in turn
initializes firebase you see it calls
firebase initialize app and now that we
want to move away from our user
interface
interacting directly with firebase we
also need to remedy this
this user interface it shouldn't go to
firebase directly it should ideally go
to our
off service
and that's what the caption says
so let's now go to our
auth provider abstract class so let's
close all these files make sure
everything is saved
let's go to our off provider
and make sure that we have a function
there
and let me actually bring up my notes
that says initialize so
we're going to say future void
initialize okay
remember now that we've added this
function to our auth provider we're
going to have problems because both the
firebase auth provider and auth service
they're they're conforming currently to
the author provider abstract class and
adding a new function to this abstract
class means that we're gonna get two
errors indicating that this function
isn't implemented in firebase auth
provider and in our auth service so we
need to fix those problems you can see
they're actually highlighted as red here
okay um
let's go then to the next caption
and i'm gonna get rid of that bottom
view so it doesn't bother us so let's go
now as you can see in the firebase auth
provider and overwrite initialize and
make it async and call initialize app on
firebase
so to in order to do the firebase
initialize code we need to have a look
at our main dart and see how that is
done at the moment you can see it is
called firebase initialize app so i'm
gonna grab that code and i suggest that
you do the same thing i'm just gonna
copy that code for initialize app
and let's then go to our firebase auth
provider
and get help from visual studio code or
android studio in order to complete that
one missing override for initialize
function
and i believe it gets added here
somewhere
or it didn't
where did it go
we should have an initialize a missing
concrete
create one missing override initialize i
still don't see the missing
i'm gonna do that here myself future
void initialize like this okay
and uh what we're gonna do as the name
indicates it's gonna be an async
function here and what we need to do is
just to save firebase initialize app so
um
and we're gonna await on this so like
that
and remember we have we need to have two
imports here and one is for the firebase
and the other one is default firebase
options so let's get help from visual
studio code to import those firebase
core
and import
firebase options dark file which if you
remember when we set up firebase
initially was brought into our
application from the firebase cli so
is is not a file that we've created
ourselves except it's the firebase cli
that created this for us okay
here now it says annotate over members
and that's exactly what we need to do so
let's just say
over
right like this and now we have
initialize uh over member of our author
provider inside firebase author provider
so
basically all we're saying is firebase
auth provider implements initialize
function and it has actual
implementation okay
all right we have one error left and
that is inside auth service so let's go
to auth service
and we'll have the exact same problem
here and says missing concrete
implementation so i'm gonna see if i can
get visual studio code to add that
implementation and it added it here
initialize okay
so in here what we have to do is just to
delegate this function to the actual
provider so we're going to say provider
and we're going to say initialize just
like that all right so this was the easy
one
and if you don't remember from the
previous chapter or maybe you jumped
over the previous chapter i don't know
how you ended up in this chapter if you
haven't watched the previous chapter i
strongly suggest that you do that there
is a reason we have our off service that
implements auth provider
and the reason behind that is that
usually services have more logic in them
than what they
bring into themselves so if a service
has two other services connected to
itself then it may actually take bits
and pieces from the service and other
bits and pieces from another service and
fuse them together with some extra logic
and that is exactly why the author
services as an odd provider so the goal
for us is to allow the officers to do
more work than an author provider even
though right now only thing it does is
just delegates all its functionality to
the auth provider and remember you could
also see make sure that i mean if you
don't like this implementation you can
for instance remove this and then
basically remove all these functions and
by doing that you're just saying that an
auth service includes an off provider
and that's all you're doing or you could
completely kill you your off service so
it's up to you but if you're following
along with this uh with this course i
suggest that you keep it the way it is
because there's a there's a point to it
so
okay
now that we've done that uh it's time to
do some cleanup and this is this is a
very exciting part of this uh
chapter because we now have our auth
service and our firebase auth provider
and in and additionally we have an off
service firebase factory which allows us
to anywhere inside our code we could
just say autoservice.firebase
and in that way we get access to
our um firebase auth provider inside the
auth services so it's it's really
magical you're gonna see it soon
so i'm going to close all files here
ensure everything is saved then as the
caption indicates i'm going to go into
main art file
main dart
and as you can see it says remove
everything related to firebase and
replace with auth service by importing
auth service okay so one way of doing
that is just to ensure that you go and
kill it from the source so you can see
here we have two firebase imports and if
you remove these two firebase imports
which is
my preferred way of usually working with
software is that i try to like remove
something from its source so now that
i've removed those then visual studio is
telling me that hey you're using
firebase in two places you need to fix
this because you don't have the imports
then i know okay
here are the two places that i have to
do my refactoring in okay
so
as you can see here it says firebase
initialize app and we need to make sure
that we're not doing that anymore so
we're just going to say
in this case our future remember is um
it's auth service and since i haven't
imported that yet visual studio is
offering to auto import it so i'm gonna
say yes please
um it's auto imported now but if you
don't wanna if you're you're working
with vim or some other a text editor
that doesn't have that capability you
could
import that in
this way
per package the name of your package
services off auth service dart
and i just noticed that this is another
firebase import which i'm going to
remove now
excuse me
so auth service now we want to tell
because we're using firebase we're going
to say auth service dot firebase and in
here we're just going to say initialize
okay so that fits in perfectly
and in here
you can see we're using firebase um
instance firebase auth instance current
user in this case we're just going to
say uh off service
dot our base man current user just like
that okay and now remember odd i talked
about this in previous chapters but
i prefer to have boolean flags prefix
with the word is
whenever that makes sense and in this
case you can see firebase implementation
had email verified but we have is email
verified so i'm going to say is email
verified like that
all right
and s or control x and linux and windows
a command is on on mac to save this file
and
it looks fine right now but we're not
really done um
we also have problems in our login view
i mean problems not errors or warnings
but problems in that we're using
firebase directly and we're going to the
firebase auth directly in our login view
and we need to fix as you can see the
caption system login view remove
firebase and replace with off service
okay
so let's go to uh to the source and
remove firebase completely from
your login view
command s and now you'll see we have a
lot of problems here and one two three
yep that was it so three three places
that we need to fix
so let's go ahead and fix those places
because yeah um
there's a lot to handle here so we start
by this one at the moment we're saying
firebase off instant sign in with email
and password
and what we need to do is just to uh
call our off service
so we're gonna say auth service and
auto imported
and auth service has firebase auth
provider and we're then gonna say assign
in or do we say login yeah email
password okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna
take this code the way it is
and i'm not paste then them in
here
so now we're saying auth service
firebase login okay
then we're seeing here that we're
getting the current user and the right
way now to get the current user is by
saying off service
dot firebase current user
and email verified should be ms email
verified okay so now we fix those
problems in this area by going to all
the search instead of going directly to
firebase
okay that was that now we need to start
looking a little bit at our error
handling and
you can see here we have on firebase off
exception
so we need to fix these with various um
other
exception handlings not firebase auth
exception
but now remember we have our own
exceptions in auth exception start
and
these are
all coming from exception but what we're
going to do is we're going to have like
on
blah blah for various of those
exceptions as you'll see soon so um i'm
gonna what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
take this code and keep it the way it is
like that
and i'm going to add new on statement so
um
let's take care of user not found so i'm
going to say on user not found exception
and you can see that it says user not
found exception is an exception that we
created manually but it's not imported
here because it was inside the auth
exceptions dart file so i'm going to say
visual studio code please complete that
and also import it for me okay
so say in this case then we have to do
show error dialog so grab that code and
place it here okay
then we're going to say
on
what else do we have wrong password
because it's this thing i'm going to say
on wrong password of exception
and go in here and grab then your show
error dialog from here
and place it there
okay
that
and then we also need to have the on
generic auth exception so on generic
auth exception
and we do this show error i like
the way it is here
so then we go and bring that here and
you can see on generic error off
exception we don't have any specific
like information like any e or anything
to string so all we're gonna do in here
we'll just say we're gonna say
authentication error
okay and then you need to go and remove
the other
catch blocks so your code should
basically look like this
okay so a try block and then three
special exception handlings one after
the other
great command s on your login view now
you shouldn't have any problems in your
login view and there's no import of
firebase in your login view just as it
was in the main dart file let's just
make sure that there's no firebase
import here either firebase
yeah firebase yeah no imports of
firebase great
[Music]
and as the caption now says we need to
go to register view and remove firebase
and replace with auth service now that
we've done the same exercise now for
login view you should now know basically
what we're gonna do in register view
we're gonna go to pretty much the exact
same thing we did in login view except
in registry removing firebase from the
imports get all the errors that we're
going to get and after we get those
errors we're going to fix the problems
in register so let's go ahead and do
that
let's go to our imports there's firebase
imported right there we're going to
remove that now we have
probably quite a lot of errors yeah
that's good
and let's go then and fix that i'm going
to go to my notes just to ensure that
i'm following all the
notes that i was supposed to tell you
about
then
we don't create user with email and
password in our auth server so let's
just say all service
and it's not imported so let's auto
import it dot firebase and we're gonna
say sign and what do we call it create
user email and password
on the end of the last parameter grab
the code and replace your firebase auth
create user email and password with our
auth service create user
okay
and in the place where we're getting the
user let's then say auth service
firebase and we're gonna say current
user
and now we have send email verification
but i think we called it some something
else we said
and
oh we didn't implement the send email
verification or did we
let me go to auth service
and
um send email verification yeah it is
right there so i'm gonna oh i see
because previously
what was happening is that
firebase implements send email
verification at the user level but we
don't have we don't want that anymore
and our user doesn't have that
functionality actually our user has just
a boolean flag
so what we need to do in here we're
going to ask our service to to send that
email verification so we're going to say
fire and auth service
and this send email verification just
like okay
all right
then we need to fix these exceptions as
well because as you saw in the login
view we don't have firebase auth
exception in this case like we've
removed the ui's
ability to talk directly with firebase
by removing all the imports so now we
need to make sure that we handle
exceptions just like we did in the login
view okay
so let's go ahead and say
um
on
each password because i think that's the
first one that we handle so
um i mean you see almost the entire
screen is now red and that's one of the
downsides of using the extension that i
talked to about during one of the first
chapters of this
course where i'm using an extension
called air lens and air lens extends and
expands all the errors that would
otherwise just happen with little icons
next to the lines it's expanding them
into their own separate lines and it
kind of makes the code look a little bit
angry at times when you're making
drastic changes to your code but don't
worry about it just have a look at your
syntax and kind of see that yeah i'm
kind of doing the right thing i'm going
to fix it soon so don't be intimidated
by all these red
flags in here okay or these red lines
so let's handle weak password exception
now it's going to be a little bit
quieter here okay
then grab your show error dialog
from there and that's for a week
password
put it here
like that and um
then we need to handle
um our
email already in use
on email already in use off exception
and we're gonna then take the code from
email already and use which is just a
shorter dialog right there put it there
okay
like that um
and we need to also handle
invalid email so i'm gonna go in here
and say on invalid email off exception
let's grab the code from invalid email
off exception
and
and and that part is done as well
also we need to have on generic als
exception so let's go in here and just
say on generic auth exception
and let's just handle that
shoulder dialog
and actually this is what we did for the
generic auth exception so i'm just going
to grab that code
put it there and since on generic off
exception we're not accepting any e so
we're not saying on catch like e like
that we could have done that but we're
just ignoring completely at the e and in
here and we're just gonna say failed to
register
and then let's clean up the rest of the
code remove the other cat statements
okay so your code basically is going to
look clean like this now so you have a
try block and then you say okay i'm
trying this code right here create user
if weak password auth exception happens
do this if email is already in use do
this if invalid email do this or any
other auth exception do this so
it looks cleaner in my eyes at least the
way we've done it now than the way we've
done it before in that before we were
going to firebase and firebase do this
do that on firebase auth exception do
this otherwise
so now the only thing we're doing is
going through our
auth service and handling
auth related exceptions and that's it
okay all right um
now that we've we've done our work in
the register you can see there's no
errors in the register we need to go to
notes view
as the caption indicates so i close
register view now let's open up our
notes view
and see what we are doing with firebase
and notes view so do the same thing like
we did before remove firebase as one of
your imports so you get the you get the
idea like an overall idea of what is
happening in here and how we're using
firebase and i can see the only place
where using firebase in notes view is
firebase off instance sign out that's
good it's just one place but we have to
fix that too so
let's then go um sorry i'm just gonna
bring up my notes as well um we're in
notes view
okay
so let's just then go to um
here and we're gonna we're just gonna
say off
auth service
all right and then we're going to say
log out i think we call it and we need
to wait on it okay
like that
and
it's bad so what we could do now
we've removed firebase from there as
well
and let's then go
as the caption indicates we need to now
go through the entire app and make sure
that everything is working as expected
but before we do that let's have a look
at our views and make sure none of them
is importing firebase so i can see login
view is not importing anything related
to firebase meaning that it's not using
firebase let's go to notes view
no imports related to firebase either
not using firebase
or at least not using firebase directly
remember it's using firebase but through
our auth service okay so no imports from
firebase here either and we have our
verify email view which at the moment i
can see
verify email view oh i see that we
haven't clean up our verify email view
and that's something that we also need
to do so we forgot about that let's
let's take care of that okay
so let's go in here and
remove this firebase auth from here as
well
i'm gonna go to
my notes here
okay
so let's have a look at that now let's
say that uh send email verification
shouldn't be there so let's just then
say fire off service
um
firebase oops firebase
a current user and i can see you see
here it was using the current user just
to send the email verification but we
don't do that anymore we just
because send email verification is not
at a user level anymore when we've
developed our off service remember so
we'll just say send email verification
like that await
all right
and then remove those two lines of code
which were just getting the user and
sending an email verification remove
those
and and to answer you i hadn't planned
for this i can actually see in my notes
i hadn't uh
fixed the verify email view and that's
why i'm not showing it in the captions
and that's completely okay i have to
improvise as well sometimes so
let's then go ahead in here in them
in the text button that says restart as
you can see here that needs to just sign
the user out so let's just say off
service
base log out and make sure that you wait
on it okay just like that and remove
this line of code as well so verify view
now doesn't have any imports to uh from
firebase either
and i believe those were
are
all of our views except for also main
let's make sure there's no firebase
imports here either
perfect so now we're done with this and
what we could do as the caption in the
case we're going to do a hot a restart
here
and let's see if things are working yeah
and i'm just going to say restart here
and let's see
the current state of the application i'm
going to bring up a firebase console
go to my notes application here
authentication and i can see i have two
users here okay so i'm gonna i'm just
gonna say pixelityab.gmail.com
foobarbass
and let's say register and then it
should give us an error saying email is
already in use so email is already in
use let's go in here and say pixelityab
gmail.combarbaz and i remember from the
previous chapters this is a user that's
already verified his um email address so
by pressing login we should actually go
to the main ui of the application so
logout should work as it did before
and let's go then to
the
uh and try to log in with the user
and that's i think hasn't
uh
verified his email address so
you can see then we're getting sent here
verify email and then we can press the
send email verification which in turn
then sends the email and to the user
so
that was a lot of information and
some improvised edition as well in this
chapter for the verify email view that i
hadn't planned for so it's good for me
to know as well that sometimes i can
miss things as well but now we haven't
missed it during talking about it in
this chapter
so
let's now
wrap up this chapter we've done quite a
lot and the main goal of this chapter is
now
we've achieved that because we wanted to
go away from using firebase directly in
our ui and going away from that using
our auth service for everything related
to firebase and that's achieved so
very well done
now what we need to do is as we're doing
in other chapters we need to uh commit
and tag all the code that we've done
because it would be
horrible if we
lost all this code for some reason
so let me change the um layout of the
screen here
and i'm going to make the
browse the editor a little bit bigger so
you see it better and i'm going to go
into the terminal which i absolutely
love in visual studio called the
integrated terminal and you can see that
in the previous chapter we had committed
and tagged our code as step that's step
eight now we need to commit as step nine
first let's have a look at status and
get add all
status and we say git commit and we say
step nine okay
and then we say git tag
nine as well and we first push our
commit
and we say good push tax
all right that's pushed as well
well done great job we are done with
this chapter and as it is uh for the
case for other chapters i've talked
about we usually talk about what we're
gonna do in the next chapter at the end
of the current chapter so
we're done with auth service it's
working fine
but what we don't have are some um tests
you see
there are three different types of tests
that you can write in flutter
unit tests integration tests and widget
tests now
a unit test is where you for instance
try to take
your current off service and then you uh
want to just say okay auth service log
in register do this do that and
given this condition i expect you to do
this now our auth service is working
quite well but
we can't be 100 sure that it is working
as it should and let's say you're
working inside a team and there are
three other people working on the same
code base with you and you work on the
auth service and then you committed
everybody reviews the code or
the way i like to do my code is to a
pair program or mob program so there's
no code reviewing because everyone's
working on the same code at the same
time so it depending on how you're
working inside your team then you send
your code then two weeks later a new
developer comes in changes your auth
service
and to and they change the service that
it makes sense to them but then they
break your code so maybe for instance
email verification
screen stops working because they change
the code so that it's not executing the
logic the way you thought it should
execute the logic so that's why we need
tests to verify that our
um
the way we design software is actually
uh is the way that it should perform its
work so that it's not missing any points
and
that's what we're going to do in the
next chapter so
um grab some refreshments and i'll see
you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 26 of this
flutter course
in the previous chapter you saw that we
started using our auth service in
our user interface code so we're not
going against
firebase directly so we removed all the
imports
to firebase in our user interface
files in the login register
main dart file and um
notes view and
also verify email view
and we have a good working auth service
however what we're missing are some
tests and tests are one of my absolute
favorite topics when i talk about
software development because
they make your code a lot more robust
than
just writing the code and leaving it in
there and i understand some software
developers may
look at things as black and white
saying that you have to have codes or
you don't have to have codes but i'm
more of a grayish person in
thinking that well you have to be
realistic sometimes you if you're for
instance writing an application for
yourself in a hackathon for instance and
in in your you're in time pressure and
you just want to get something out well
that's not the right place to write a
unit test if you're in a hackathon
but if you're working with a company and
they and you're getting paid to write
good software and you're getting paid to
write your tests as well to make sure
everything's working out as it should
especially if you're a back-end
developer software like a front-end
developer
then you will need to ensure that your
code is tested properly so
i'm going to bring up the caption
here
about why we actually need tests and
especially unit tests
um and we're going to talk about the
different types of tests in a while but
let's just talk about unit tests um i
mentioned in the
like the outro to the previous chapter
about what unit tests are
and why we need them and
for me the main reason having a unit
test is to ensure that if you if you
think here's the auth provider we left
it in a state that well it's working
okay code codes on code working so
it's working but what if a new developer
comes into the project and
tries to change some code so that it
works for her or for him
but unintentionally changes it changes
the code so that it's not working for us
the way that we intended it so
that's why that's one of the reasons we
have unit tests okay
um so that's what we're going to do in
this chapter and i completely understand
that this you if you're watching this of
course you're probably sitting somewhere
in a calm area a calm room and you're
watching this course yourself it's the
chat i think the chances of you watching
this course with a group of people are
quite slim so
um and chances are you're just following
along with the course and you're trying
to write an application or release it to
the app store or play store and play
store
so
maybe you're not so interested in making
sure that your auth service is actually
tested and i completely understand that
but i'm basically designing this course
for people who are trying to become also
good software developers so if you're
coming as i've mentioned like one of the
personas that i developed this course
for are designers so if you're a
designer have no background in flutter
development you may also be interested
in writing tests for your application
especially if your goal is to go into a
bigger organization and actually get a
job as a flutter developer or as a
software developer so
given that background you should know
what tests are what unit tests are
integration tests are and what for
instance widget tests are in flutter
now i need to also mention that
there's something called a tdd or test
driven development and
the right way of actually
doing test driven development is to
first
write the tests and then you write your
software at the moment we're doing it
the exact opposite because i didn't want
to complicate uh things as we're going
because i have this as i said i designed
this course for someone who's probably
new to flutter development or software
development in general so like going
into test development test driven
development directly and then writing
our off service probably would have
complicated things more so in for the
sake of simplicity we wrote the code and
then we're writing the test but just so
you know if you're if you hear people
talking about tdd tested with the test
driven development what they mean is
that you write the tests and in the
writing of the tests you come towards
the conclusion of how the interface of
the class you're actually writing the
tests for should look like if you're
working with classes
so test driven development is there's
very important and we should be aware of
it how to use it and if you're
working in a software development
organization you should do test
development test
driven development if time allows and if
um all the constraints are in the right
place for you to actually do tests and
as i said i look at things more like in
a not in a black and white um
vision more like a gray vision
i say that you should do tests but that
is again something that is completely up
to you and up to the situation that
you're in so
just be aware of what tdd is and that
the right way of doing test driven
development is that you first write your
tests
and then you write the interfaces and
the code that the tests are actually
performing their tests on there's lots
uh lots and lots of resources online
about tdd and what it actually means how
it should be used tdd flutter as well so
i strongly suggest that you have a look
at those resources as well and maybe
perhaps after you've gone through this
chapter and done like the basics of
doing tests
now um you see we have time limit in
this course because this course can't go
on for hundreds and hundreds of hours um
first because i i wouldn't probably be
able to put so much time i know that
this course is already gonna go over 20
hours of time but
it is it is going to take a lot of time
if you want to go and cover everything
and all different types of testing
in flutter so
for the sake of simplicity and making
sure that you follow along with this
course without dropping off and getting
scared of all testing things that we're
gonna do i'm gonna give you like the
basics and i'm gonna give you the
building blocks that you're you need in
order to be able to carry on later on
your own and write more and more tests
so
i just know that the reason we're
dedicating this chapter to testing is to
make sure that everybody understands
that testing is very important but also
we are not going to have many many many
hours just to focus on testing
though it is a very important subject
now let's talk about different types of
tests i mentioned this in the outro to
the previous chapter and but i'll
mention it here in case you've jumped
over that chapter which i don't
recommend and if if you talk about
different types of tests in the flutter
you should know that there are unit
tests widget tests and integration tests
and let's just quickly talk about
what these different types of tests are
well um
let's go and talk about the concept for
instance of a class let's say you've
created a class called auth service
which is the case for us and you want to
write some tests for this class now this
class is very isolated in its own in its
own like it is it has a set of function
functionalities functions and it has a
getter called current user
if you don't remember that let me just
bring it to the screen so you see better
um so let's go to our auth service
it conforms to and implements the auth
provider it has a constructor it has a
factory constructor here as well and it
has all the functionalities that are
provided by the auth provider because it
implements auth provider so i'm gonna
actually increase the size so you see
better
so um
this is a unit of itself so it's a an
isolated piece of code that talks with
an auth provider and then it gives us uh
basically mirrors the functionalities of
that author provider which in in this
case is that in the firebase case is the
firebase auth provider so
it doesn't have so much functionality
but it has functionality good enough in
order for it to be tested and it's
actually important to test it just to
make sure nobody unintentionally changes
this code without without consulting
with us or without like and making sure
that their changes aren't gonna break
our code so that's unit tests so you
have a unit of code you have a piece of
code isolated and you want to test that
piece of code and to ensure the
different functions inside that code um
are working as they should so that's
just like a general idea of what a unit
test
is now a widget test as its name
indicates is a way for you as a software
developer in order to make it as a way
for you as a software developer to make
sure that your widgets like the ui that
you are creating is working as a shift
for instance if you have a login view in
your application
and this login view allows the user to
tap on a button in order to log in and
you're saying that okay in the ui i'm
going to make sure as soon as you press
the login button
until the user is logged in that this
login button should be disabled okay so
that's a piece of logic that you thought
about good idea you put that code in
there
but how do you test it how do you make
sure that the login button stays
disabled until login is successful
that's where widget testing comes into
play so widget testing is some sort of
uh like an end to end test and by that
we mean that your widgets are probably
talking with your services and with your
providers
so
your widget for instance the login
widget
or the login screen upon pressing the
login button is gonna call into your
service in this case the auth service
and it's going to go into this login
function this login function in turn is
going to talk with a provider the
provider in turn is going to talk with
the firebase code which in turn is going
to talk with the firebase backend so you
see the layers are stacking up ui is
here the button is on the ui
ui is talking with auth service
here auth service is talking with the
provider the provider is talking with
firebase firebase is talking with the
firebase backend and maybe the backend
is also talking with some other services
so
that's end to end it's one end and the
other end is right here so
you are basically by writing widget
tests you're doing end-to-end testing in
a way okay so that's widget tests
the other things are integration tests
you see
an integration test is where you for
instance have a service which we have in
this case the auth service and the auth
service is in this case the auth service
constructor or the factory constructor
is talking with firebase so if you test
our off service the exact way it is in
that you go and say auth service
firebase
and then you
issue commands against this auth service
firebase you create a user you sign in
with the user you log out you send an
email verification
if you're doing these tests you are
actually doing integration tests so
you're because you're making sure that
the code is also working end-to-end but
there's no ui involved so
uh
but
i mentioned i mean you're now thinking
okay what if testing auth service the
way it is is integration tests how come
you said in the beginning of this
chapter that we're going to do unit
tests
and that's what we need to talk about
now because you see in this unit test
exercise that we're going to do in this
chapter we're not actually going to call
firebase we're going to call we're going
to do something called mocking
i don't know if i've actually
mentioned some something here
yes i can see that later i'm actually
going to talk about mocking
and mocking in english it could mean
that you're making fun of someone and
that's not this and what we're talking
about here mocking is kind of like you
imitating um a real service so imagine
you have the auth service the off
service has a firebase factory talks
with firebase and it turns talks with
the firebase code and then talks to the
backend we're going to get rid of all of
that pipeline and say we're going to
test off service but we're going to give
it
another provider a provider that we
control you see the fire the firebase
auth provider has a lot of code in it so
we can go in there
let's go in the firebase auth provider
it talks directly with firebase but what
if we could create an
auth provider that conforms to auth
provider and then write a lot of logic
in that auth provider and provide that
author provider to the auth service
now all of a sudden we have an auth
service that delegates all his tasks to
this mock
um
auth provider that we control the code
for so we know exactly what the sign-in
is going to do we know exactly what the
sign out is going to do or log in and
lock it depending on the terminology
that you like to use
so
what we are going to do in this chapter
is mocking and i'm going to explain that
soon so let's just jump over that for
now
okay
um
the next thing that we need to talk
about are dev dependencies
if you're coming from like a node
background if you've worked with nodejs
or express you know already about npm
which is the node package manager
and you know what dev dependencies are
in there
if you're coming from an ios background
there isn't much of a dev dependency to
be honest with you except if you're
coming from an ios development
background then you know when you're
writing your tests those test frameworks
etc that you bring into your test target
there are inside their own target so
that they're not shipped with the final
product if you're not coming from any of
those backgrounds and you just want to
know what dev dependencies are all
explaining now you see when we're
working with our application if we go to
our pop spec yaml
you'll see that we have a section here
called dependencies and at the moment we
have dependencies on various libraries
for instance firebase core
firebase auth cloud firestore and
firebase analytics these are the
dependencies or libraries that we're
bringing into our application
which if you think this is our
application these are the various
libraries coming in and then we're at
the end
actually at the end of this um
course we're gonna send our application
to app store and google play store
when we create our application to send
to these respective stores we're
bundling the application and all the
dependencies together and sending this
as a complete binary to the respective
um
app store
however you also have a section here in
your pop spec yaml called def
dependencies
now dev dependencies are dependencies
that you use and bring into your
application only
during the development of your
application meaning that when you ship
your application which is a term used
for
saying that when you create the
application and post it to the
respective app store for instance for
review then those dependencies aren't
actually packaged inside your
application so they're only inside your
application while you're developing it
and as soon as you package it up and
send it for release then those
dependencies are not going to be packed
inside the application all right
so
those are dev dependencies
now let's go to our
testing here
so as you can see here we need to bring
tests into our
into our flutter application to make
sure that we can actually run our tests
so you will see here flutter test is
already included i'm going to show you
the command that you'll need to issue in
terminal in order to bring it manually
as well
and that is if we go in here and just
type flutter pop add test dev
all right
it's doing a pop get there
okay this job is done now now let's have
a look in here
and you can see now we have a dev
dependency called test and that's how
you bring it into your application using
this command so i'm going to bring it up
again just so you see it flutter pop add
test and and a dash dash dev if as i
said if you're a node
node.js developer you'll know this from
npm
d which adds it as a development
requirement or dependency to your
application so
i'm not going to assume that you brought
in this test package into your
application with the command that i
provided here for you in the terminal so
if then you look at your pops back yaml
file so i'm going to bring this down
if you look at your pop spec yaml file
inside dev dependency then you should
have this test package only inside your
dev dependencies if you see that is
brought into the dependency section that
is incorrect it shouldn't be there and
that is because you've missed perhaps
adding the dash dash dev at the end of
your flutter pop add test command so if
you do it like this
then test is going to be added to
dependencies and that's incorrect so
make sure that you fix that error
okay so let's go to the next section and
talk about that now if you bring up your
explorer you will notice that if you go
to your test folder the entire test
folder at the moment is marked as red
and and
uh actually it's not marked as red like
an email it's is is
rendered in red color that's what i mean
so it could be um maybe
heard in in the wrong tone so if you go
in there that folder was read and then
if you click on on this file which is
called a widget test that file is also
red has a lot of errors here actually no
it has one error because it's creating
something called
my app so
what we need to do in here because we
don't need this existing test you see
this test was created for us when we
created our flutter application we need
to get rid of it okay so let's go in
here and right click on it and just say
delete and that file is gone okay
so that's the first thing that we have
to do
and collapse this leap folder here as
well
now what we need to do here as a caption
indicates we need to create a new file
called auth test dot dart okay
so let's go ahead and do that under the
test folder so
let me go ahead and do that right now
under the test folder right click and
say new file and then call it off test
dart
all right
okay and what we need to do then in this
off test start right now this function
is completely empty so let's first
add a main function in here
like that and you can see as soon as we
add the main function in here dart is
intelligent enough to give us a run and
a debug functionality here and that's
displayed in visual studio code i think
android studio also does the same thing
i don't think vim is availa is able to
do that it may be vim is time and time
again has surprised me with all this uh
amazing capabilities
uh but depending on the
um on the tool or the text editor or the
id that you're using this could be
different but don't worry about it we're
not actually going to click on these
things so if you don't see these things
in your text editor you don't have to
worry about that
so
now that we've done
adding the test package now that we've
imported test packages that depends we
also need to import it so let's go in
here and say import
and get rid of this editor sorry
explorer on the left hand side and i'm
going to say if we import a package
called test
and there's a file in there called test
start so now we're ready basically okay
all right um
now you see
you may not have noticed it but
i have this application already running
on my actual android phone as we've done
in the previous chapter so i never
killed this application without a reason
it's always running on that android
phone i can always bring it up with scr
cpy so i can see right here that is
running without a problem
however
remember one of the previous chapters
one of the first previous chapters when
we talked about adding firebase to our
application i think it was chapter five
or six it was very early in the course
when we brought in firebase we need to
we needed to kill the application
meaning that we needed to terminate the
application and run it from scratch
so
depending on some dependent actually no
i don't think it's depending when you
bring in a new dependency in your
project you need to always ensure that
you rebuild your project so you cannot
do hot reload and hot restart because
some of these dependencies they actually
need your application to be
compiled from scratch
and then
then be brought into your binary so hot
reload and hot restart aren't going to
actually
like be able to bring those dependencies
yet at least into your flutter
application so what i need you to do
is to stop the execution of your program
and then let's go in here save these
changes then let's go and say
main.dart
and let's run the application
without debugging and let's see if this
is going to launch the application
correctly on the right device as well
and i can see yes it is going to run it
on the correct device i change the
screen layout a little bit here as well
so
let's just then wait for uh this gradle
belt to finish doing its work
it might take some time depending on the
changes that you've made to the
application in this case we brought in a
whole new package called testing to our
application so
it is taking its time and that's
completely fine
and i can see now it has
run our code without a problem great
stuff for this chapter i don't think we
need our um device with scr cpy if
you're using ios simulator i don't think
you need it if you're using an emulator
i don't think you need it either so we
could just get rid of it so we don't
have to display it on the screen but
remember my application is still running
okay
so
um let me get rid of this here get rid
of the widget inspector get rid of the
main dart and let's go to our auth test
dart file in here
okay
now one thing that we also need to fix
before we start writing our tests is
this little functionality here this
little guy in our auth user
if i bring up off user here
you'll see that it has the way we left
it is we added a
um we added a member variable to this
off user immutable class here called is
email verified and the way we're
constructing this auth user if you see
here we're saying off user just give us
this william so if from anywhere inside
your function and you have
a if from anywhere inside of your
application you want to create an
instance of off user you'll probably do
like this off user and then you have to
pass that boolean is email verified
however you'll see that
parameter has no name
it's just a true or false
if i as a programmer see auth user true
obvious or false i don't understand what
this true or false is what does that
even mean does that mean the auth user
is turned on is turned off what does it
mean
for that dart has the capability to give
you required named parameters and that
means that
instead of passing true in here you will
be forced to write off user his email
verified true or false like that
so in order to do that as the caption
indicates we need to go and make this a
required parameter and the way to do
that is to
wrap it inside curly brackets like this
and then prefix it with the word for the
keyword required
so after you've done that and this
function is not going to work anymore
because this parameter is missing so
it's email verified
and we're gonna pass
this value right there
okay and let's just move that remove
that function so
now we've achieved what we said we're
gonna do
now
um because you see we're not gonna we're
not actually you may think that okay
we've changed this parameter to required
so where are all the errors in our code
why didn't anything break and that's one
of the beauties of what we've done so
far and that we've abstracted away so
much code that the code is a lot more
robust now so because nowhere inside our
application we're actually creating us
users except from this factory function
the only place we have to fix this is
email verified is inside this factory
function so
to me that's beautiful because
doing something like drastic by adding a
required parameter to a class it didn't
break anything so we're just good to go
okay
all right um
now this is the point that i mentioned
previously that we need a mock off
provider all right
in order to do a mock author provider i
need to go a little bit more into what
mocks are and why we need them you see
in software um
we have especially in testing as well or
even as the app architecture level or
software architect architecture level we
have something called dependency in
injection
dependency injection
just quickly explaining it is very
similar to our auth service let's have a
look at our off service here you see off
service is dependent on an auth provider
and it's not just making the assumption
that it's auth providers always firebase
it provides a factory for firebase but
it's not making an assumption about that
hey i'm always locked to firebase auth
provider
this is dependency injection so this off
service is dependent on a provider using
a
constant constructor initializer we're
injecting the provider into it
this
in a nutshell is dependency injection in
software development
you could go into a lot more details
about it but we don't have time for it
um
so what is a mock the mock goes very
very well
hand in hand with dependency injection
in that in this case you can see we have
an off service that is mirroring the
functionality of its provider which you
could inject into it
but
the provider that we're using at the
moment is called firebase what if we
created a
completely new provider that we have
complete control over we can we can make
sure that it conforms and implements
auth provider and we can make sure that
it implements all those functionalities
that is that auth provider implements
and overrides all those but we have some
special logic in our own
mock auth provider
then we will give this auth provider to
our auth service and then let the auth
service do its magic and and mirror all
those functionalities of the provider so
we're gonna mock an off provider and
provide that into our auth
service so that's what mocking is when
you when you create a
a new function or a class and then you
can then
inject that into another
place and then test that another place
okay
so let's go in our off test dart file
that we have right here i'm going to
command s on it and let's go and create
our little off like mock off provider
so i'm gonna go in here and i'm just
gonna say class mock off provider and
suggest you do the same thing and this
guy is gonna implement
um
the auth provider okay auto imported for
us okay so like that
all right
now what we need to do is just to get
mock-off provider
to implement all the functionalities
that the auth provider apps abstract
class requires us to implement so i'm
going to command dot on it and
respectfully ask visual studio code to
create those six missing overrides thank
you so much visual studio code for
making our lives easier
okay
now what we need to do is just to do the
heavy lifting of this mock auth provider
which means to go ahead and create the
functionality for the auth provider okay
i understand that the code is completely
ginormous right now so i'm going to
decrease the size a little bit so you
see more of the code
so let's go ahead and take care of the
first function in here which is create
user
okay now you see
what we're going to do is
if you remember
our auth provider
has a function called initialize all
right
now when we're using auth provider in
the context of firebase firebase
internally has the concept of whether it
is initialized or not
but when we're creating a mock auth
provider where is that functionality we
don't keep track yet of whether our mock
auth provider is actually initialized or
not
and we just have an initialize function
but what if someone calls create user on
our mock auth provider without having
initialized the provider yet and that's
what we need to do now
so let's go ahead and keep track of that
so what we're going to do here is we're
just going to say var is initialized
it is false to begin with okay
and the reason i'm saying underscore is
initialize is because um
this is making this property pretty much
private to our mock-off provider so
we're indicating to the outside world
that hey you shouldn't be reading from
this property or writing to this
property
okay that is done now let's create a
little getter for this property so that
when we're testing our mock auth
provider we can actually say
hey are you initialized
and we can also create a test for a mock
auth provider which we're actually going
to do is to say okay when we create the
mock auth provider it shouldn't
initially be initialized however after
calling initialize on it then we make a
test to make sure that initialize flag
is set to true so let's in order to do
that we need to be able to read this is
initialize flag let's go ahead and
create a boolean getter for it we call
it is initialized
it's initialized and we just return is
initialized in there
all right
now let's go into our create user i'm
going to put a comma at the end of that
parameter i'm also going to take the
liberty of going and creating and
putting a comma at the end of login
function
and that's the only two places that had
that required a comma at the end of
their parameter list so now dart
formatter is able to format the code a
lot better
okay let's go to create user now you see
in create user i'm pretty much in all
these functions that we're writing in
here for instance login send email
verification we're we need to make sure
that this mock auth provider is already
initialized so we're actually going to
throw an exception if you call these
functions that require initialization
without having initialized the mock auth
provider first so let's go and define a
um an exception in here
so let me see actually if i have written
that down somewhere
nope so let's go in here and just say
class
not mini
initialized exception
implements
exception so you should know this from
before
and it's empty for now
okay
so what we need to do in here we need to
just say if
is initialized if it's not initialized
then throw
not initialized exception
okay
so that's an if statement it's a
one-liner that's why we don't really
break it in here otherwise you put curly
brackets in here and then do the
throwing in there but you could also use
a one-liner if statement if that's all
if that's
what you're doing just one line of code
all right and i kind of like these
one-liner if statements to be honest
with you so i hope you got this if the
mock auth provider is not initialized
throw that particular exception
and what we're going to do is just we're
going to fake creating a user okay so
we're just going to say
if you call the create user on firebase
for instance it probably needs to go and
talk with firebase back-end so it's
going to take some time so let's build
in some little uh delay in here
and what we're going to do is just to
say future
and delete
and here you have to pass the duration
to it so we say const duration
seconds
and they do
i believe that's it
let's just say one in here and remember
future delayed if i go and move over
it's a function signature it returns a
future of dynamic so by creating a
future you're not actually waiting on it
so let's mark our function as async and
let's just wait on it
okay now
do then is to make sure that
um
this create user actually returns an
author user but remember also in
firebase um or i don't actually know if
firebase works like this by but by
creating a user what we're going to do
in our mock auth provider is actually
logging that user in as well okay
so
let's just say you see login returns
also a future of auth user so at the end
of this create user we're just going to
make our lives easier and just return
the result of logging in so let's just
say return
and log in
when
this email and password okay
so this is a very dumb and very easy
mock implementation of create user in
itself it does three things checks to
make sure that you're initialized and if
you're not initialized it throws an
exception
it does a mock uh one second wait just
to like fake making an api call and the
third thing that it does is that it
calls the login function with the same
email and password and returns the
result of login just so that it can get
its off user
okay now we need the mock current user
so
how do we do that how do we get a
current user you see
firebase has the ability to keep track
of the current user but how do we do
that we can't just go and delegate this
functionality to firebase right now so
we also need to create an auth user in
here okay so let's go to deter mock auth
provider right there
off is initialized or below it doesn't
matter somewhere i'm gonna do it above
i'm gonna say user
like this
you see in far in a dart if you make a
member variable optional by default it
is null so it has no value so you don't
have to actually go and say no and you
can see it says don't explicitly
initialize variables to no good good
analyzer
i don't have a user that we're
internally going to manage and i'm
actually going to make it prefix it with
an underscore so that it is marked as a
private function as a private member
variable
then in the current user simply return
that user so like this okay
perfect
now
we need to go and take care of the
initialize function let's see if we can
find it
login here is initialize
so
the only thing we're going to do in
initializers we're going to fake waiting
just wait for like a second
and and then set r is initialize flag to
true so let's grab this code of a weight
from our create user function and then
bring it to initialize and then just say
await and make your function
asynchronous and then we're gonna just
wait
and we're just going to say initialized
is true
so that was an easy one all right so
then the meatiest part of our
mock author provider is actually the
login function because it's not that
it's doing login but it's also
the function that the register
function is using or do we say create
user
create user so that function is also
logging the
it's calling the login function so we
need to really test this function to
ensure that it's working properly okay
as i mentioned before in most of these
functions when we need to make sure that
our mock auth providers initialize
before these functions are called on
them so let's go and grab this code you
see it says if is initialized and bring
that code as well in our login function
so that's the first thing that we're
gonna do
now
we're also going to build in some fake
functionality into the login function
just so we can write tests for them
because you see in the real world you
probably have like lots and lots of real
logic that is
inside your uh auth providers and auth
services but we don't have all that real
logic right now because our application
is quite small right now so we're gonna
build some fake functionality into our
mod provider and then sorry in our mock
auth provider and then we're going to
write tests that test those
scenarios so you learn about mocking and
you'll also learn about writing tests
for those mocks okay so that's the
entire purpose of this chapter
so
what we're going to do then is we're
going to say if
and so we're going to make up an email
that we don't like we're going to say if
email is
um fooatvar.com
then throw user not found exception okay
so if you're trying to log in with this
email address we're just gonna say user
not found okay
and if password
is foobar
unlike the foobar password either then
we're going to say throw
wrong password off exception so
remember
login in itself if we go to our
firebase auth provider so go to this
file firebase auth provider dart it has
those functionalities like if you have a
look at login it has a functionality
like handling user not found wrong
password generic auth exception so what
we're doing is that we're creating some
sort of a mock of kind of the same thing
but we're locking it to specific email
and password okay
okay so that's for password we don't
like the email of foo at bar.com and we
don't like the password of foobar
now
we're also going to remove the
unimplemented error here now in this
case let's just create a user so we're
going to say user is and off user
and it's email verified we just say true
or let's just say false actually so we
say when you're trying to log in we're
just saying is email verify false okay
now that we've created a user let's
assign it to our user
like this because remember we have a
private field called
underscore user and we
just keep hold of it like this
and then we will do because remember we
need to return a future of that auth
user then we say return future
of a value equal to our user like this
so
that's our login function
that was quite a lot of work but i think
you hopefully understand what we did
right there
now we have to look at a logout function
and the logout function is gonna have
some code as well so
um it's not just gonna be saying okay i
logged out as i mentioned before we need
to make sure that the
mock provider is initialized so let's
bring that code in here
boom okay and we also need to make sure
if you want to log out that you've
actually logged in before so let's just
say if
um if i can find my keys
if user is null
then throw
uh user not found off exception okay
otherwise what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna await
so let's find an await code from before
we're just gonna fake waiting a little
bit just one second okay
and and we're gonna set our user as well
to null we're just gonna say the current
user then is not you can see it's
complaining that we're using a weight
but let me just say in here then
async
just like that then the error goes away
because if you mark your logout function
as async then you can wait on a future
so easy as well logout says am i
initialized
and in order for me to log out there
needs to be a user and then i'm gonna
fake waiting one second and then i'm
gonna set that user to null so easy pc
okay
now let's mock our email verification
code
so same thing so you should now be
familiar with this let's just make sure
that we are initialized i'm going to
grab a code from there room throw
unimplemented error actually let's leave
it
let's leave it there okay
for now at least
and um
then during the send email verification
what we're gonna do is you see when we
did a login we said that uh let's have a
look at the login we said by default the
email for the user's email verification
is false but upon send doing a send
email verification we're just gonna flip
that flag where all of a sudden i'm
gonna say oh now outside of your email
verified
which which isn't so realistic but
that's the logic that we're mocking
right now okay and remember a an auth
user
uh here
has a and it's email verified it's read
only like you it's a constant you cannot
change it so
just because we have an optional user in
our mock auth provider it doesn't mean
that we can just go and say off user is
email verified true we can't write to it
so we need to rewrite this entire user
okay
so
after checking that you're initialized
what we're doing is saying that
if
let's get the user actually final user
is
this let's get your current user and we
say if user is null
and throw user not found so our
send email verification code is make
sure making sure that you've logged in
before you can send an email
verification or at least you register
your user okay
um
okay
then what we're going to do is to create
a new user we're saying new user is an
off user and his email verified is true
this time and then we set that as our
current user so we say the current user
is the new user
and then we just remove that and we make
our sure our code async as well
okay
so that's for send email and
verification
so you see
it did take a while but we've actually
written now a mock auth provider that
has its own code and it has its own
initialization etc okay
now what we need to do is to
talk actually about tests so
um
let's see yes um
so what are test groups and what are
tests you see
if you think of tests as or at least
unit tests as pieces of code that test
other pieces of code
you may think okay i'm going to write a
test for create user
here i'm going to then write a test for
current user i'm going to write test for
initialized login blah blah now all of
these are common and group they're kind
of related they're all testing mock auth
provider and that's what test groups are
for in your test functions in flutter
sorry in your tests and test suites in
florida you can actually group your test
functionalities into a group that has a
name and then you can ask flutter to run
that entire group of tests for you so
that's what test groups are for
so now what we need to do is to go into
our main test function right there and
basically create a group and then add
provider inside that so let's just go
ahead and then type group
and in here we're just going to say mock
authentication okay
and let's go in here the second
parameters as a function
and like that so now you should have
your code like this so basically you
created a test group and you can see
visual studio code is telling me that oh
you can run this group
so we're gonna put all our mock
authentication tests inside this group
okay
and as a caption says the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna create our
an instance of our mock aus provider so
let's go ahead and say a final
provider
is a mock-off provider just like that
okay
so
now we have that
so now we're getting to the juicy parts
and i'm so happy about this because
we've done quite a lot of groundwork
just to get to this point for this
chapter
so now we're gonna write our first test
so as you can see the title says testing
provider is initialized providers
shouldn't be initialized to begin with
you see we're starting with
a
an assertion we're saying that according
to our implementation the way we've
implemented our mock auth provider it
should not be initialized to start with
so we're just making sure that by
creating an instance of mock auth
provider it's is initialized the boolean
getter
should return false if it if it returns
true we're going to fail our tests so
meaning that if someone then sneakily
goes into the code later and says oh
this is true by default then the tests
are gonna fail and all the developers in
the team are gonna be notified about
that okay
so
let's create our first test the way to
create tests in flutter is that you
start typing test okay
and you give it a name in this case i'm
gonna say should not
be initialized to begin with okay so
that's the name then you're gonna
provide it with a function to execute
upon doing its test
and in here you could say you could use
a function called expect
and you say writers
provider is initialized
it should be false to begin with
all right so
that's the first test that we wrote so
test function then you write a name for
it then a function to be executed and in
there you can use various flavors of the
expect function you'll see
expect there are various flavors of that
so
right now we're just expecting the easy
initialize flag to be false
okay
now the next test that we have to do um
so as the captioning case test logging
out before initialization the provider
should throw and not initialize
exception
so
basically what we're saying is that
according to the log out function it
shouldn't be able to log out if it's not
initialized first so we're literally
testing this line of code okay to make
sure that no one just unintentionally
comments it out or unintentionally
removes the same we don't need it all
right so let's test that uh
functionality so let's just say test i'm
going to look at my notes to see what
i've named there
cannot log out
if not initialize okay now you know that
as a second parameter to your test
function you need to provide a function
so uh
parenthesis
and then curly brackets and in here
we're just gonna say
expect
and now we're using a new flavor of this
expect and in here i'm just going to say
provider log out
and upon calling this logout function
we actually want to expect an exception
so there is a really good
uh catch that you can use in here that
is called throws a
and you can see throws a is a matcher
and it matches the result of the log out
function against whatever you provide
here so you say throws a
and then you expect
an exception in here you see the const
type matcher
height matcher is just going to say not
initialized
exception so i'm going to type this and
then i'm going to show you what i'm
doing basically in here
see what i've done through jose const
blah blah blah huh
that looks fine as well
and let's see why type manager is not
extract method cons throws i probably
messed up something
in here yeah
so let's see what is happening here so
what we're telling expect in here is
saying that execute the logout function
and
we're now testing the result of that
function against something called a
matcher and matcher is because you see
in here you can't say that this result
should be an exception because what are
you going to do are you going to create
a
an instance of that exception that's not
that's not a good way of testing your
functionality in here you're saying
you're matching the result of calling
the logout function it gains that
expected type as you can see type
matcher is if you go into it you can see
is a matcher
okay so that's how you would expect a
function to throw an exception all right
all right a lot of information um
now what we need to do after testing
that functionality we just need to make
sure that we can actually initialize our
mock provider
i'm going to bring the code a little bit
up here so you can see it better
so
now let's
go in here and say test and let me see
it should be able to be initialized
should
be able to be initialized
and create an empty function in here
then what we're going to do is just to
say await provider
dot initialize like this
and remember just like everywhere in
your dart code you can make your
functions asynchronous just by putting
async right before the curly bracket so
it's not a part of the signature of the
function it's just telling dart that
inside this function i'm going to
execute some code asynchronously okay
so upon initializing we then after
initialize if you look at the code that
we did for initialize
it just does a uh
and a weight of one second and then it
sets the flag of is initialized to true
and we can read that flag by reading
this boolean getter so let's say away
provider initialize and then we're going
to say expect
the provider is initialized flag to be
true after this
all right so that one was an easy one
so after we've done all of this you see
is initialized and doing initialization
is not actually going to create a user
for us so let's make sure upon
initializing our provider that the user
is no so let's just say test
user should be null after initialization
okay
empty function
and then let's just expect the user the
current user to be known so let's say
expect
a provider current user
that it should be known all right so
easy to read and it's almost like
reading english so
so that's it
all right now what we're going to do is
doing some asynchronous testing i want
you to see this as well because it's
very important now let's say that you're
we want to test as the caption is
telling you testing the time required to
initialize we can test timeouts in this
case so
what we're going to do is look at our
initialization code here and let's see
the initialize function here
at the moment is waiting one second what
we're going to do in our test just for
the sake of using how you can test
timeouts and how you you can test for
instance api calls in the future we're
going to do some asynchronous testing in
here with a timeout saying that our test
should fail
if initialize on our provider takes more
than x amount of seconds all right so
now let's go in here and say test um
should
be able to initialize
in less than two seconds
okay and an empty function which is
asynchronous just like that
empty body for now
and what we're going to do in here is to
say await
on the provider's initialization
okay
and after initialization we're also
going to expect the is initialize flag
to be true just like that
however we're going to
use a new
parameter of our test called timeout
now timeout will provide a constant
timeout to it
with a duration so
duration and in this case we're just
going to say two seconds and i think we
have one extra parameter in here
constitution timeout
argument zero expected what one found
cons time and then here seconds
and avoid cons here okay so this is very
simple simply said we're saying that
we're created a test that calls the
initialize function on our provider and
just ensures that that function returns
to the test context before the timeout
has passed so internally this test
function which you provided timeout to
is going to create a little timer and
then it's going to set the timer to
start with as soon as it calls the
function
this function in here let me show you
here this
as that is
progressing and doing its work it's
going to terminate its result processing
as soon as the timeout basically passes
so in this case our initialize function
is going to take one second to process
this work if it can't do that during
these two seconds of timeout that test
is going to fail okay so now you know
how to test that as well
so let's go in here and now test the
medius part of our
provider which is creating a user as you
can see we have to test make sure that
creating a user actually delegates to
our login function and we have to test
all the edge cases all right
so let's go ahead and do that let's then
say we test
uh create user should delegate um
delegate
to login
function and in here we're gonna create
a function which is an asynchronous
function all
and what right
need to do is to create this
basically if you remember create user
doesn't have internal logic of its own
it's just going to call login but login
has this beautiful logic that first test
fooadbar.com
with any password should throw this
error user not found off exception so
let's just test that scenario okay let's
go in here
and say final bad email user is
provider create
uh
writer oh don't we have our provider
oh i've added this test i apologize i've
added this test i believe at the end of
this entire test group i should have
added it here so if you've made the same
mistake i apologize for that it's my
fault you should fix that and make make
sure that your test is in the same group
where it has access to the provider so
then i'm going to say provider and so
final bad email user is
uh provider creates user
the email is fooatbar.com
and password could just be any password
okay
comma semicolon make sure dart formatter
formats your code properly so then what
we need to make sure is
when the bad user is
basically returned to us then it should
actually contain a user not found off
exception so let's go ahead and say
expect
a bad email user
to actually be of
to throw a
const
type matcher
of
that user
not found off exception like this
okay let's see
and i
have to close that here as well
so we're basically saying calling the
bad email user the creation of a user
with that specific email should throw a
user not found off exception and
remember you may think oh we've tested
this before yet but that was in the
context of
here let's see
actually no we haven't tested that
before it's it's this thing that we've
tested so sorry about that so we've
tested a lot yeah we haven't tested this
particular case so
all right so
now we've tested that now let's test
this scenario with a bad password a
password of fubar you see we have that
logic in our mock provider here for the
login function let's test this scenario
now let's test this code we should throw
the wrong password off exception okay so
let's go in here and say
final
i can see that you can't see the code so
bad password user is provider and create
user with the email of let's just say
someone at bar.com and the password is
fubar and that's the password we didn't
like remember that okay
now we copy the code from here
and then we say
that that password user should throw an
exception called wrong password
off exception okay so we've tested that
scenario as well
now we actually should test the um
the positive scenario so let's go ahead
and say final user is awaits provider
and we say create user
all right
an email is going to be
foo and the password is going to be bar
remember our our mock auth provider is
not actually testing whether an email is
correct email or not
firebase is doing that but a mock
provider isn't doing that so
we could just provide any email
foo and password a bar and it will just
accept it as long as it's not
it the password isn't foobar and as long
as the email is not footbar.com okay
all right now let's let's make sure that
this user is then being assigned to the
current user of our auth provider okay
so let's expect the auth provider
offer sorry the provider's current user
to actually be equal to this user okay
because um
that's what we did in our create user
remember we create user delegates this
work to the login and then login
internally sets the current user to that
user they just created okay so that's
the scenario now we're testing with this
line of code here
all right so that's that
um
so what we need to do then is just to
make sure
by just creating a user which we're
doing here that the is email verified
functionality sorry that is email
verified um parameter of our auth user
is set to false by default remember
login function here
is set is email verified false let's
test that functionality okay so we just
say expect
users
we use email verified to be false
right
wow that was a lot of
code to be honest with you and i hope
that you got everything that i mentioned
here
so now that we've done that let's test
the email verification functionality uh
and let's have a look at what we
actually did in email verification
you see we have this functionality not
initialized
then we take the current user if the
current user is null then we say user
not found exception and then we create a
new user with is email verified to true
and we're then setting that user as the
current user so that's what the send
email verification code is doing okay
now you see
when
when flutter then runs our code it's
going to run them sequentially so it's
just going to go from top to bottom and
then you remember
before we test the email verification
we're actually testing create user which
in turn calls the login function so
since we're keeping a hold of our
provider
this create user calling login function
ensures that the current user actually
sets and is not email verified so we can
count on that okay
so let's say
that we test
and we say login user should be able to
get verified uh logged in user should be
be able
to get verified
okay and then an empty function in here
um like that
so in here we then say provider send
email verification okay
and with the final user is providers
user uh
current user
like that
and we now make sure that the current
user is not null so we say expect user
is not uh or
yeah expect the user is not null which
as you can see is a great matcher that
you can match something against it so
you say shouldn't be no okay like that
all right
and then we also we need to make sure
that this user's uh verification is set
so it's email verified should be true
then we say expect and we'll get an
error now you'll see user is email
verified it should be true
okay and you can see you get an error
here saying that a user is optional but
we're gonna
and do an asterisk here saying that
force force on rapid for us okay
now what we should do as the last test
we as the caption says test logging out
and logging in and this is normal
scenario that should just work let's
create a test for it so let's just say
test
and we're going to call it should be
able to log out and log in again should
be able to log out and log in
and again okay
and an async function
so and a semicolon at the end
so what we're going to do here then is
just to say
log out and log in and then we get the
current user and we just make sure that
you're not
null so let's say a wait on the provider
to log out
and we say await on the provider to log
in
with an email of just user and password
just like that okay so or just email
because we're not actually validating
the email and password in our auth
provider in our mock author provider
and then we're going to get the current
user so we say final user is provider
current user and we just make sure that
that user is not known so let's just say
expect the user is not null
which is a method built into
flutter tests
all right that was a lot of work and i'm
proud of you for
sticking with this chapter
we talked a lot about tests there's so
much that you need to go through so much
material and you need to learn on your
own as well about different types of
matters and different flavors of expect
and talking about expect i kind of
expect you to go
and read these things also on your own
and learn about them in your own time as
well
now the exciting part we need to run our
tests so let me change the screen layout
and
let's go in our terminal here
and let's increase the size
and
let's then
uh break this and as you can see you can
tell flutter to run your test by saying
flutter test and providing that path to
your test so now flutter is going to go
ahead and issue and go through those
tests one by one
and let's see what we get as the result
and you can see it's giving like time
for all of these tests and it says all
tests passed now i just want to
highlight this before we go on we did a
lot of tests i've prepared these tests
manually so to make sure that they
actually testing important functionality
inside our auth provider however i've
written the tests very carefully to make
sure
that they work
this is not the case when you're doing
things in real life your tests should
fail if you've done things right your
tests should fail to begin with and you
then need to go and write your and fix
your logic if you're doing things even
more right you should write your tests
first nothing is going to work then you
should go and write your logic to fit
those tests and expectations so just
because these tests are passing right
now i know we have joy inside we say oh
everything's passing everything's great
but in reality that's not going to be
the case usually okay
so
a lot of work we did let's do as we
usually do keep the tradition and let's
commit our work and and also tag it so
let's then say git status to see the
status lots of things changed
hey
hit add git status
all right we're going to commit this as
step 10
and we're going to say in here get push
it's going to push our commit to github
and then we get the tag as well as step
and push
tax
traditions as it is tradition in this uh
philosophy course we always talk about
what we're going to do in the next
chapter before we wrap up the current
chapter so as you can see the cache has
said let's get ready for the next
chapter we need a database to store user
notes before you use or if we use
firebase for storage now
you see we at the moment we're not
actually writing anything anywhere there
are no nodes uh
the user can't even create new nodes so
but what if we wanted to give the
ability for the user to create new nodes
and then delete those nodes and update
those nodes and
uh to begin with uh we're going to store
these nodes in a local database inside
the application so you will learn in the
next chapter
about sqlite
and local databases and how to use them
with firebase
sorry and how to use them in flutter
in the latest chapters
in the later chapters we will change
that logic so we'll be won't use sql
lite uh but i believe for any developer
uh
if you're like a
i can't say any developer but if you're
a front-end developer or a back-end
developer you should be comfortable with
databases and that's exactly what we're
going to do
in the next chapter so grab some
refreshments and i'll see you in the
next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 27 of this
flasa course
in the previous chapters we've been
talking about
our user interface and also we've been
looking at our um
services and
we've put some
time also to create some um
tests for our services and providers
up until this up until this point we've
been talking quite a lot about like the
logic of going from one screen to the
other uh integrating with firebase etc
however we haven't actually talked about
storing um user created content
inside our application or inside some
sort of cloud service
what we're going to do in this chapter
is we're going to talk about sql lite
and storing user generated content in
this case the user generated nodes
inside sqlite now
i'm gonna get to what sqlite is but
first of all let's have a look at the
title of this chapter which as you can
see it says crotlocal storage for
those of you who are software developers
from before and are comfortable with
crowd you can just jump over this
part of the chapter for those who are
not familiar with crowdcrot stands for
create read update and delete these are
four very fundamental operations that
any developer would perform on their
data and for instance if you're a flask
or a django developer node express um
developer you're you're probably already
familiar with these because
you're probably using some sort of a
database mysql or sqlite
um and you're storing your data in there
and you're just working with the data
and you're familiar with the term crop
but if you're not familiar with it then
think of it as c which is create is you
creating
some sort of a an object inside a
database some such as for instance a
user generated note
you read of course want to be able to
read that data back for instance in our
application's main user interface you
may want to read the entire contents of
the database
not the entire contents but at least in
user generated notes for that specific
user so that's the r in crowd
then you have u which is for
which it stands for update um or it
doesn't stand for update it means update
because u is the first letter of update
so on update is for instance if i have
already generated a node inside this
application i want to go and change the
contents of that node then that's the u
in crod
and um last but not least you have d
which is delete um and as its name
stands basically you
you allow the user to be able to delete
their own generated content from the
database so
what we're going to do in this course is
to um
talk about sqlite that is a database or
a c
library and a library created in c
um
that allows us to
see as a programmer language c that
allows us to store data inside a file
now if you're if you're coming from like
the backend world if you're if you're
programmed with inside with python in
django you're already familiar with this
because sqlite is the default database
that will be provided to you in django
and a flask as well i believe is using
sqlite by default which is very similar
to
django
but if you're not familiar with sqlite
is i've prepared a website here which i
mean i haven't prepared the website i've
just opened the website so
um
so you can see here i'll increase the
size of the font here and you can see
sqlite is a c language library that
implements a small fast self-contained
high reliable full-featured sql database
engine sqlite is the most
used database engine in the world well
just think of sqlite as the database
engine that we're going to use in our
application and it's not something that
is built in inside um flutter we will
have to use a so-called plug-in for it
um
but that's also okay and i mean not many
languages have support for talking with
a database and natively so
um
but we'll get there we'll get to that
point okay
now let's talk about how we're actually
going to integrate with sqlite and to
start with so i'm assuming that you
don't you have never worked with sqlite
before or you haven't worked with any
type of database before and you're
trying to learn how to do that okay so
that's that's been my assumption from
the beginning of this course so if
you're already seasoned developer you
know exactly how school sql light works
you may want to jump over this section
of this chapter and get to like more
juicy parts where we integrate actually
with equal light inside the floater
application
so let me close this um or maybe let's
just keep it open
and what i'm going to talk about now is
um a program
a free program called db browser for sql
lite you see sqlite allows you to
i mean if you think of
sql lite has different components first
you have your database which is just a
file that sits on a disk
and then you will have the sqlite
engine that can read from this this file
and write to this file so that's the
engine and then this engine should run
somewhere so it's either going to run
inside an application such as the one
i'm mentioning here a db browser for sql
light okay so sqlite's like baked into
that application or you can also bring
sql light into your terminal so that you
can actually talk with sql lite
databases from within your terminal
or if you for instance have install
django on your computer then you can use
django in order to integrate with sql
iso sqlite is the engine that talks to
the sqlite files
uh which are your databases but then
it this engine should run somewhere it's
not just an executable that like you say
here take this file you now have to have
like some sort of a container where the
sequel light engine basically resides
when we then talk about our flutter
application we're going to bring this
engine into the flutter application so
our app can talk with that database but
for now we're going to look at a program
called db browser for lite db browser
for sql lite is a free and i believe
it's an open source program let's search
for it
i'm going to say
db browser for sqlite
and we end up in this
website and um and as you can see the
official home of the db browser for
sqlite and this is how the program kind
of looks like
um i'm not sure if yeah i can see now
it's actually available for windows mac
os and it would be amazing if it was
available for linux as well
um yeah
so
it seems to be available
uh and you can actually use snap so
that's great so if you're on ubuntu like
i am
not on this machine right now but if
you're on ubuntu you can actually use
snapstore or even debian any type of
operating system linux space operating
system that has snapstore so that is
really good even on arch linux fantastic
all right on debian you used apt so
that's fine but anyway so it's available
for windows linux and mac os so i need
you to basically go to sqlite browser or
db browser as it's called db browser for
sqlite if you go to the home page i need
to find this website
and let me change the screen layout so
you see it better
and i need you to download this program
okay i've already downloaded it on my
computer so i'm going to close that
safari window and i'm going to bring you
the db browser for sqlite as it looks
like on my computer
the only thing i've changed on my
interface here is i've changed the font
from 13 to 20
not because i don't like the number 13.
it has nothing to do with that but it's
just i thought 20 is a little bit of a
nicer font size for this course um
all right so what are we gonna do now so
um let me then talk about
the structure of our database and how
we're going to set it up
if you think about how we've created our
user interface in that here's the user
interface if we go here you can see that
we can register with different users so
then we have a user entity or a user
table as we're going to call it
and then we also have
we are going to allow
the creation of these users in our
database so imagine that we will have
some sort of a table some sort of entity
in our database that is dedicated to
users and users are probably just going
to have
a
what are they going to have they're
going to have an id and an email so as
you remember when you create a
when you register a user with firebase
you always get a user identifier so
we're gonna store that id
plus the user's email in our database
okay so we're not gonna store the user's
password that isn't that is an absolute
no-no okay
so user id which comes from firebase and
the email address we're gonna store in
our database
and also
we are going to have another table and
another table in our database dedicated
to notes so as a user when i log into
the application i should be able to
create my own notes and these notes
should be kind of like bound to and like
they should be glued to my user so if my
user is in the database i should be able
to have notes and if my user is deleted
all those notes should kind of also be
deleted from the database so it's kind
of like a cascade for those of you who
are familiar with back-end development
so
that is like the structure that we're
going to set up for our database so
in our i can see in my notes that for
our notes table we are actually going to
have a user id
integer in that table that like binds
the
every node object to the user who
created it but we'll get there so don't
worry about it
so i'm going to get rid of this
here and put it there
so we don't see it
now what we need to do is start testing
so we want to create a database a simple
database and start creating some tables
in there okay so what i need you to do
is just to press the new database and
i'm going to save it on my desktop and
let's just call it testing okay
and i'm going to press the
save button right there
okay you can see now we created a
database and we have a table here it
doesn't look so nice i mean it's not
rendered so fine because i've changed
the font on my screen
but you i think you can you get the idea
okay
so what we need to do is to as the
caption says we need to create a table
called user okay
so go in here at the table section here
and i'm improvising a little bit here
because this is like something that i
plan to show you but i haven't actually
prepared any notes for it so let's just
go ahead and create a table here called
user and as you can see we're gonna be
able to have some
um
fields in here what is called a field in
here is pretty much just like a column
so
by creating a field you're creating a
column okay and the great thing about db
browser for sqlite is that you can see
the sql
code that will be generated for you
which we're actually going to use later
when we integrate sqlite into our
flutter application but for now i just
want you to get the idea of how sqlite
works how it creates the tables et
cetera okay
so now we have the user uh
empty table it doesn't have any fields
or columns i need you to press this add
button right here and what we're going
to do is we're going to just create um
an id
field
now if you're not a developer or
software engineer friend before you may
not
know about id field and why it's
important or if you're a developer from
before you may know id as primary key
from before
so
um an id is just usually an integer
identifier an integer is a number so a
number identifier for every row that you
later later insert into your table so
why is it important because
usually an id is something called a
primary key and a primary key by default
is
unique what that means is that for you
to be able to create a user in this
table it has to have its unique
identifier now
if you remember how our um
how we are basically treating users in
our user interface is that we're
treating them by their email so you may
think well the email is a unique
thing as well so why don't we go with
uniqueness off the email well we can
apply uniqueness constraints on the
email field and or the email column but
it is very well established pattern in
database um
world where you're working with
databases that you i mean you can make a
string column
unique such as then such as an email but
a primary key is usually an integer such
as pk or id so it's just a convention
and it's also a good practice to not go
with
like a uniqueness of a string because it
takes more resources in order to
calculate the uniqueness of a string
than it takes for an integer so we're
then going to call this field id
going to be integer and there are some
fields in here which are not rendered so
well i'm going to increase the size of
this and i'm going to do
like this
okay
so
what we're going to do in here um
we're going to take you see n n in here
at the type we're going to leave as
integer that's fine n n means not null
meaning that this field should always be
present it should never allow the value
and emptiness of the value or the
absence of a value to be present there
okay the absence of value to be present
i hope that makes sense basically just
means that the value cannot not be
either so we're we're going to leave it
like that pk stands for primary key and
that is what i oh actually i can move my
mouse over them that's great primary key
so um
it means that it is the key using which
is a unique key in this
table using which we should be able to
then easily query
different users from this table so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this item right here okay
ai is auto increment i believe and auto
increment is a great functionality in
sqlite and many other uh databases that
allows you as the as the name uh
suggests
and as the name indicates that by you
creating for instance a user with a
specific email and you insert that user
into the database in this table
and you don't even have to assign an id
to that user you just say here is the
user email boof put it in the database
then
excuse me then sqlite is smart enough to
say oh i but i need an id field as well
you haven't provided it and then it
looks at this field and says oh id is
auto increment so it's going to create
that id for you and increment the
previously generated id and assign the
new id to your object for instance if
you have no objects inside this table
and then you add a new user then it
automatically gets the id of zero
and then if you generate the next user
and put it in there then it will get the
id of one so you get the idea okay and
that is exactly what we're gonna do for
this particular field
and unique is just yeah as its name
indicates this field needs to be unique
but if you indicate something as primary
key implicitly it is a unique field okay
and to be honest with you we could
actually check not null as well meaning
that yeah it should always be there so
just in case
so that's for the user field okay
sorry it's for the id field
and now let's go ahead and create a new
field for the user's email
like this and for the email you should
say that it is a text okay
and what we'll do we'll say it shouldn't
be null and also the emails are unique
so have a look at this now it generated
code for it that says create table user
id integer not null email text not now
unique and it sets a primary key of id
with an auto auto increment so
this is kind of like the code that we're
actually going to use in our flutter
application in order to programmatically
create this table
later but for now just keep it in mind
this is kind of like the syntax of
creating a
sqlite table programmatically okay
all right so then you can press ok in
here
and now you can see the user table has
been created for you and here's the code
for it or the schema as it says right
there
all right
great stuff now as we did the user table
we need to go and create our notes table
because remember from before i said
we're going to allow the user to create
notes when they're logged into the
application and by the time they're
actually logged into the application we
should have already created a user uh
row for them
in the user table
and then by creation of every note we're
going to create also a new note in the
database in our note table which we're
just going to create as the caption
indicates
and then we're going to bind that note
to that user in the database so
i need you to go here then and then we
need to create a new table by pressing
create table button okay
so as the caption in the case here let's
call this new table note
and we're then gonna start by creating a
new field called id and we've already
gone through this you know exactly what
to do in here an id field as integer and
we say it shouldn't be in it shouldn't
be null
it should be primary key
and
and i think that's it to be honest with
you so not null and
auto increment as well of course so
all right so that's for that's for the
id of a note now
what other fields do we need in here so
what we could say is for instance that
you have a a user id and so you want to
bind a user to a node
and what we're gonna do in here we're
gonna bind this we're gonna say
literally that this oops where did it go
oh it's a little bit strange interfacing
here so that's okay too
um so user id integer and we're going to
say it's not null
and also what we're going to do is to
what we want to do is for this user id
to be kind of like bound to
a user tables id field and that's that's
called a
foreign key so you have a primary key
which is the key that your table itself
manages as its own field and then you'll
have a foreign key as its name indicates
that it is it is a field inside your
table that is bound to another tables
something else column so in this case
our user id should be bound to the user
tables id column and you can create that
with db browser for sqlite inside
constraints
and in here let's see
we add a constraint and we say we have a
foreign key
and in here
so let's say
sqlite foreign key
and we say the user id
and we say apply
and you can see now it says foreign keys
or id references it's not at the moment
referencing anything
so
i wonder if that
field is hidden somewhere to the right
hand side
and how we could possibly create that
let's see i just remember from before
that this was a little bit strange to
get working from the beginning so
name oh maybe it's it's the name right
there so
so let's say user id references
sqlite foreign key let's see how it's
created foreign key user id
references
let's just say name
should we say um in here if i say blob
what happens
foreign keys ready references
contains blah
so that's not that's not really what i
wanted in there so i'm going to remove
this plot that i just created and let's
see if we can change the sequel we can't
are there no other fields available here
that we can play with
perhaps not
and i want to remove this just to see if
i've made any mistakes in there so
let's say
so here i can see we have a user id and
then there is a foreign key and i can
see here this is perhaps the right
actual way of doing i remember there was
something really strange about it and
now i remember that it is hidden under
this foreign key um column unfortunately
i believe it's a little bit of a strange
interface that's okay i'm just still
very very grateful that we have db
browser for sqlite as a free software
and perhaps even an open source software
i'm not sure about that and i'm very
grateful for every developer who's
worked on this so
i just hope that it um
that's understood but what we're going
to do here in here we want to bind this
user id to the id field of the user
table so just click here under foreign
key and double click actually i can see
then this magic thing appears here
so let's go ahead and say that we want
to bind this to the user table id field
and
i believe that should be it yeah and you
can see now the code generated here says
we have a foreign key called user id and
it references the user table id field
okay
perfect um now we also need to do is to
create another field in here and that's
the text of every note
so what we're going to do for notes is
going to be very simple our notes are
not going to include any sort of
um
they're not going to include any sort of
for instance um
images they're not going to include any
sort of
ordered list or unordered list they're
going to be simple texts okay and they
don't even have titles the title of a
note we're going to derive from the text
of the notes so
it's very simple
so for the text of the note let's just
go say it is of type text
and uh
i believe i believe that's all we need
right now so
user id text and yeah that's fine and
also to be honest with you if you want
to you could also create a other fields
in here you see in this uh in this
course what i what i want to do in the
beginning is to allow us to create a
local database that you can store all
the users notes in it but i want you to
also be able to
later in the future get rid of this
local database and replace it with
firebase that's like the goal um however
some of you may actually decide to keep
this local database store the user's
information in this local database and
not the user's information the user's
notes in this database and then you may
want to decide to have some sort of a um
utility service that sits in the
background and syncs these notes with
firebase at appropriate time so
that's up to you if you want to do that
then you may want to actually create a
little fill in here that's called is
synced with server or something like
this okay
or it's synced with cloud i've
called it in my note so let's go ahead
and do that although we're not actually
going to use this field but i just want
to demonstrate to you that this field is
possible to
achieve with
sqlite
then in here let's say it is an integer
also
um and we're going to say the default is
0 meaning it's not synced
basically true or false in
true could be translated to any value
that is not 0 and 0 could be translated
to the value of false so putting the
value of
zero in here meaning that it is not
synced with any cloud
storage
so let's then go ahead and say that uh
this is integer and it's um we should
say it's not null and um and it doesn't
have to be unique so now you can see
that this is the result of the creation
of our tables this is id integer not
null and the id is also primary key in
auto increment then there is a user id
which is integer not null but it's also
a foreign key to the user table under
the id column
or the id field and then we have another
field here says text of type text and
then another field that's called isync
with cloud integer not null default zero
okay so
that's all we need to do
and i'm going to press okay and i need
to do the same thing on your side all
right
now we have two um
we have two
tables in our database
so let's go ahead and um
let's go ahead and move on to the next
point that we're going to talk about you
see as the captioning case we need to
create these programmatically otherwise
we have to move this
database that we just created called
testingdb
manually into the documents folder of an
application i'm going to explain what
this actually means you see
now we have a file called testingdb it
has the database for our application
with some tables okay
however
we need to be able to create these
tables programmatically if they don't
exist inside our application you see
this testing db for me is sitting on my
desktop it has absolutely nothing to do
with our flutter application and you
could be smart and like drag this db
into your firebase application flutter
application and then kind of copy it to
the right place when the application is
is executed in the user's telephone or
on the tablet
and then try to read from that database
it is possible but what i'm going to do
in here is i'm going to show you
a better way of doing this in that we're
going to actually create these tables
programmatically in our flutter
applications so that
you also see that process and how that
works how can you integrate with
sqlite inside your flutter application
okay
all right so in order to do that as a
captioning case we need a few
dependencies uh we need sql sqflight
path provider and path
and um i'm gonna then explain to you why
we need these dependencies you see sql
sqflight is a package it's a third-party
package that we need to add to our
application in order for our flutter
application to be able to talk with sql
flight
so that's that's that and that is for
storage actual storage and talking with
the database that package used for okay
now there is a dependency that we have
to drag into our application called path
and path is used for us to be able to
grab the applications documents folder
so that we can actually create a file
inside a documents folder and place our
data inside that file just like i'm
placing the data for nodes and user
inside this testing db file on my
desktop so
the path
uh provider and the path provider uh i
may have actually taught set paths but
it's actually called path provider path
provider dependency allows us to grab
the the applications
documents folder and if you're not
familiar with mobile application
development you may not know this but
applications that sit on the uh on an
android phone or tablet and on ios
telephone or ipad os tablet
they have their own file structure so
every application in itself has a
document
directory so
whereas on your computer like if you're
sitting on a from a laptop or a desktop
you have a documents folder that other
applications that run on your operating
system could get access to so it's one
documents folder every application can
request access to and store information
in it and read from it but that's not
the same concept in mobile devices and
on tablets in that every application
runs inside something called sandbox the
sandbox is like a it's like a
cage inside where the application
resides and all the application data
resides in that sandbox so
every application can request access
from the operating system to read its
own documents folder okay and that is
what the
path provider
package is gonna allow us to do
to find our applications documents
folder in which we're gonna store our
database file
now
we also need as i mentioned a
a package called path
and
we need this path just for a very single
up a simple operation and
let's say that we have uh use path
provider to get our documents folder now
we want to
create a file in this documents folder
and kind of like get the full path of
this file documents folder slash
this file and that's what we need the
path package because it has a great
function called join that allows us to
take the path or of a directory or
folder and
join that path with a file name and it
gives us the entire path
back so we can access that file okay
so
a lot of information i'm gonna take this
um into another
screen so you don't see it and i can see
here it's asking for to control this
computer's access now i'm going to deny
that for now
um all right so what we're going to do
i'm going to bring our code up if i can
find it
and here's the code how we left it in
the previous chapters
and i can see that it is running
excuse me in scrcpy i'm going to bring
it here i'm not actually sure if you
need a crcpy in this chapter so it may
be better for me to just to minimize scr
cpy
and i'm going to make this code a little
bit bigger here as well okay
so
so what we need now
is to first before we go ahead and
actually create our notes service is to
bring in those dependencies okay
let me change this screen layout a
little bit so you see better i'm going
to increase the font as well
so i need you to go to your uh
editor text editor or id if you're using
and we need to bring in those uh
dependencies okay
so let's go and bring up uh your web
browser and say pop.dev and in public
dev search for sql flights okay and you
can see it's right there and the way to
install it is very simple you should be
able to just say
uh flutter pop at sqflight so let's go
ahead and do that by hand
and let's give it a flight remember it's
not sq sqlite it's sqlite
okay that dependency has been added then
i'm going to say flutter pop add provide
a path provider and we can actually
search for it in popdev path provider
and it is right there
it's developed by the people who have
brought us flutter and so to begin with
at google so it's not really a third
party application or third party uh
package and we can actually have a look
at sql flight as well and see who's
developed that
oh it's another yeah it's another
publisher is not flutter themselves so
let's go back to path provider
and i'm gonna just say
installing as we can see is flutter pop
add path provider let me just copy that
and paste it there
add path provider
and then we also need path so let's go
back in here and just type path i
believe this is my flutter team yeah
dark dev so let's just say flutter pop
add a path
alright that's going to do its work and
now if you go to our um
pop special
then you should be able to see those uh
dependencies sqflight path provider and
path are right there okay
now that we've done that we can go and
do what we uh are supposed to do in here
which is create our notes service you
can see that in the
uh in the description i've provided here
in the caption i said that we're in
creating inside a folder called crud
and we already have lib services you can
see in here lib services and lib
services auth but we don't have crud so
i'm gonna go in here in lib and just say
new file and i'm gonna say services
well slash
absolutely it's saying that it already
exists so inside services i'm going to
say new file then i'm going to bring it
so you can see it as well oh where did
it go
services new file
crud
i think i need to change the screen
layout so unfortunately so you'll see it
better services again new file in here
a new file uh third time or fourth time
lucky crud and then nodes service
dot
okay so
what we're going to do with this node
service is to uh
is to basically grab
a hold of our database it is the primary
service that is gonna work with
our sqlite database it's gonna grab
users it's gonna
create new users delete users it's gonna
find users it's gonna create notes
delete nodes update nodes everything
everything that we need from our user
interface this
node service is going to
facilitate that for us okay
okay so
what we need to do inside uh are
so what we need to do now is to actually
i think before we do that we need to
import our dependencies so
let's import our dependencies we need uh
three dependencies if you remember path
path provider and sqlite so
um i'm gonna
bring those in here so we don't have to
type it again
so imports are kind of like boring and i
i don't rather not type them so let's go
in here and you can have a look at what
i've imported here package sql flight
and then we import that
then we also have the path provider okay
so that we can get the documents folder
for this application and then we also
are importing package path path and then
i'm doing this show syntax in order to
bring in this particular function called
join all right
so
you could also skip that but the problem
is that then you get everything inside
path of dart and that's not what i want
so i just want us to get this particular
function inside
path.dart and you could also do the same
thing in here to be honest with you you
could just say show um and i think the
function is called get application
documents directory so let's do that why
not let's just get that particular
function from path provider as well okay
we don't need the entire path provider
all right
all right that's great
so
what we need then is for us to be able
to
grab a hold of our
current database path as i mentioned are
every application that you develop with
flutter for mobile application mobile
devices such as android and ios and ipad
os they have their own documents
directory and we're going to create and
we're going to get the path of the
documents directory and then we're what
we're going to say is we're going to
join that using path
dependency
with a name that we are going to specify
for our database okay
so
um
what we need to do then is to let's go
ahead first actually and take care of
some other important matters that uh
need to be dealt with before we actually
create the function functionality for
for our database uh implementation you
see note service is going to talk with
database but before you can do that it
needs to have some sort of dart
representation of those two two very
important tables that we created um user
and note so if you read that data from
the database how are we going to
represent it inside our dart application
and for that we need dart classes
so
what we need now is to as a caption in
the case we need database users create a
class called database user inside notes
service dart
all right that is going to be a bit of
code so i hope you're ready for it
and let's just go ahead i'm looking at
my notes
let's go ahead and create as the caption
indicates we create a class in here
i make the
a little bit bigger class and i'm just
going to say database user okay
now if you remember from db browser for
sqlite i'm going to bring it here every
user had
can we actually
oh we can browse it but i want to go
back to the user
and modify the table save it and you
remember it had an id and an email id
was integer and email was text so that's
what we're going to define in here okay
so we're going to say final and id and
final string
email
get help from visual studio to
completely complete this i'm not going
to explain these again and again because
we've explained this quite a lot in
previous chapters so by this point i
just assume that you know what these are
let's make this a constant initializer
and then let's go ahead and say these
two
parameters are required parameters so
they become also named parameters by
default okay
and that's that put a comma here so we
get dark formatter to do its magic
and what we're going to do
is remember when we
actually you shouldn't remember because
you don't know this maybe yet but when
we talk with
our database we are going to read
like hash tables
for every row that we read from our for
from that table so every user inside
that database
table called user is going to be
represented by this object a map of a
string and an optional object okay so
that's a row inside the user table
now imagining that the
this
node service that we're going to create
soon
reads these
users from the database and it should be
able to pass this to our database user
class and the database user class should
create an instance of itself
depending on the values inside this map
all right so let's go ahead and create
a constructor we call it database user
and then we say front row
and then we say we get a map of a string
and an optional object in here and then
let's just call it map okay
so what we're going to do in here is
we're going to create the shorthand for
creating and constructing our object and
we'll say the id is equal to inside this
map there needs to be some sort of a
column called an id column so instead of
hard coding that in here like this let's
go and define a constant here and just
call it id column and let's just say
that this is equal to id and in here
we're just going to say id is equal to
ib column just like that all right
and then what we're going to say is we
also need the email an email is equal to
map
and remember we have the email i'm going
to open the user in here
modify table
and let's go and have a look at this
email which is text right there okay
so
the table that column basically is
called email so let's go and go ahead
and create const i'm going to make this
a single single code as well because
that's like the preferred way of doing
it and let's call it email column and
i'm going to assign this to
full email and in here i'm just going to
say email column
as a string
and this should be as inked so
this was
i mean it looks complicated but it
really isn't so and you can see it's a
constant so we could also actually tag
this as immutable and we need to import
foundation in order to be able
to do that
okay
now that we have our database user we
need to also implement a few more
functionalities for
this class before we're actually done
with it
so the three things that we need to do
for it is first to create like a string
descriptor for this class so that if
we're printing out this user to the
debug console
otherwise
i mean before i say otherwise if we're
printing out an instance of the database
user to the debug console so we're
looking at the various users that are
inside our database
if we do not implement two string on our
class it's literally just gonna say
instance of database user in the console
and that's not so useful so it's my it's
my um
habit to if i'm planning to print out
these things to the console it's my
habit to go and implement two strings so
let's just in here say to string
and it gives us the overwrite and what
we're going to do in here is just we're
going to say a person
and person
id is equal to dollar id
and email is equal to dollar email okay
so that's for your to string
then what we need to do is also
implement some sort of equality
behavior for our class you see we want
to be able to see if two different
peoples that we've retrieved from the
database are equal to each other or not
so if if i say if person x is equal to
person y then like read the person wise
notes such as something like that so
let's go and implement equality for our
class and the way to do that is you
overwrite
a boolean operator and it's called bool
operator equal equal
and in here you would have a covariant
which we haven't talked about yet and i
will talk talk to you right now about it
so
what covariance is is a keyword in dart
that not many people know about but it
allows you to change the behavior of
your input parameters so that they do
not necessarily conform to
the signature of that parameter in the
super class so remember we're doing
overwrite here meaning that there this
functionality this operator is already
defined at the object level so let's go
to object
just type object somewhere for instance
void hello
and then say object and then command
click on it just so you can go there and
search for operator
equal equal and you'll see in here that
it says external operator equally and
the parameter should be of type object
now we don't want to do that we want our
classes to be compared to other classes
of the same type so if you don't
put covariant in here you'll get an
error from the
analyzer and you'll soon see that
actually we're going to remove that soon
so
in here we're saying that we're going to
compare our class with equal equal and
instance of our class with equal equal
and we're going to compare with another
user of the same class okay and then
here we're just going to say our id
should be equal to the other id that's
our equality
now let's go ahead then and remove this
covariant as i promised you
and now you'll see you'll get an error
saying that oh wait a minute according
to object equal equals should compare
the current object with another object
but using covariant you're telling dart
that hey i'm not comparable with other
objects of any other class i'll only
comparable with database user instances
so make that happen all right
so
then after you implement equal you have
to also implement hashcode as is
suggested by the analyzer so i'm going
to get help from the dart
from visual studio code and i'm going to
say create method hashcode
and in the overwriting of hashcode i'm
just going to return my id's hashcode
okay so this basically the id is
becoming the primary key of this class
using which it will hash itself so it
can be placed inside maps or
hash nodes if you're
if you're a ros developer or
a dictionary if you're a swift developer
so
uh that's hashing okay so it feels like
we're actually done now with this um
with the with our database user so
and that was quite a bit of code but we
managed that
all right now that we've done the
database user we need to do something
similar but this time we need to do it
for our nodes so we have a database user
now we have to create something called a
database node okay note
not node
and i'm going to do that under the
database user just so that we can have
closer access to these constants all
right
so i suggest you do the same thing so
let's just say we create a class and we
call it database note
and remember from our database schema
that a note so if i go in here and say
right clicks right click and modify
table then we had id user id text and a
field call is synced with cloud all
right so let's go ahead and do that id
is integer user ids integer text is text
or string as ins is synced with cloud
it's just an
integer in here but we're gonna
represent it as a boolean all right
so keep those four fields in mind so
let's go ahead and say final id and
mint id
and we have a final int in our database
we call the user underscore id because
that's a convention in sqlite
or sql generally that you don't put you
like you don't write your fields with
user uh
id usually you don't type like this the
way we type with camel case in dart in
other languages we just say user
everything's under everything is
lowercase and different words are
separated from each other with
underscore but that's not the case in
dart and other languages instead we say
user
user id like this with panel case all
right
and we're also going to create let me
just move this a little bit there and
we're also going to create um
the string for our text
and
last we're going to say is synced with
cloud something like that all right and
again remember we're not going to use
this input cloud it's just for you to
understand how we create different
fields in the database
and yeah it's just it's just something
that you future you guard yourself
against future changes in your database
schema so by doing this you're allowing
yourself to play with this field so that
you know every note that is locally
created in the local database is not by
default sync with the cloud all right
i want to get help from visual studio
code to complete the constructor for
this and i'm going to go and do
all of these fields as required so i'm
going to say required and i'm going to
copy that paste it right there paste it
right there and there and then i'm going
to put a comma at the end and command s
on mac or control s in windows and linux
to save this and get dart formatter to
format this file for me
all right so that's the initializer
and we kind of also need to do the same
thing that we did here for our database
user and that we need to instantiate it
from a row so let me copy this code the
way it is right there
and i'm going to bring it into our
database note i'm going to paste it
right there and instead i'm going to say
this from row initializer creates a
database note
in our database note we have an id
but we don't have email so in here we're
just going to say user id
is map then we need a new column which
is called user id column okay so let me
just see my notes how i created it
yes i can see it's called just user id
call so go ahead and create a new
constant in here
and call it
user id column which is if you remember
from our schema it was called user
underscore id
so user id
okay
and here we say user id is equal to map
user id column
as a string and it's complaining right
now because we have two more fields to
initialize but we haven't really read
their values from the map so text and is
synced with cloud so for text we're just
going to say text is equal to map
and let's go create a new
consonant in here we say text column
and that's equal to text so it's just
the name of the field or the column here
you see
so let's go ahead and say that's text
and in here we say text
column
and we say add string and i believe
that's how we call it yeah
and we'll be calling a string can be
initialized oh sorry about this the user
id can't be a string it should be added
in so let's just say it's an int and
last but not least is synced with cloud
so we're to say
async with cloud actually is read from
from our database as an integer remember
is synced with cloud as an integer so
we're going to say
we're going to first define a column for
it is synced
with cloud
column
and we're going to call it async with
cloud and
i mean i'm saying uh we're going to call
it but actually we've already called it
we called it is synced with cloud so
just need to copy and paste that in here
you see
okay and then we're going to say is
synced with cloud as equal to now
you see we don't have this uh
data we don't have this field as a
boolean in the database we have it as an
integer so we have to read it as an
integer so we're going to say in the map
there's a column called async with cloud
column and it's an integer okay
if that is equal to one then
return true
otherwise uh
is equal to one true otherwise false so
you see what happened here we read the
column as an integer
and oh if it's equal to one then this
guy is equal to true otherwise this guy
is equal to false okay
now that we've done the initialization
of our
database notes from the from the row we
need to go ahead and
we need to create the tostring as well
for our database note okay
so let's go and overwrite to string
like this
and we're just going to say this is a
simple
note we're going to say
is equal to note
and its id is equal to dollar id is text
is equal to
or just its user id is equal to dollar
user id
which is a field that we have
and then we are not going to print its
entire scene is an entire text instead
we're going to say is synced with cloud
is
other is synced with cloud just like
that all right
all right so yeah i mean optionally you
you may also add text if you want to
it's kind of up to you but
the problem is that the text of a note
could be so long that it actually gets
in the way of you getting information of
your class instance such as its id user
id and a single class so maybe if you
want the text to be there just add it at
the end so it basically doesn't disrupt
the rest of the fields that you may
actually have interest in reading okay
so we did the
implementation for
from uh tostring right now but we
haven't done the equality so let's go
and overwrite the equality as well and
the hash node hash code sorry
i'm going to copy that code from our
database user and bring it into the
database node and i'm going to then
paste it right here so you can see it as
well
we're in the equality we're saying that
we're comparable with a database note as
long as our id is equal to the other id
then we're good to go
for the hash code then we're going to
get our id's hash code all right just
like we did for the other class
wow that was a lot of work to do
okay now we've created the database note
as well as the caption indicates um
so what we need to do now is just to
make sure we have all our constants in
place before we carry on now remember
right after doing these classes we're
going to go ahead and create
our um the actual note service that
talks with our database all right so
before we do that let's create all the
necessary constants such as
the file under which our database is
going to be saved so let's just call it
bb name and we're just going to call it
notes.db all right remember this is like
the file name okay now we're going to
create and you can see in here in our um
file here in as db browser for sqlite we
call this file testing.db and in our
case we're just going to call it nodesdb
and we're going to store it in documents
folder inside that application okay
and then we have two tables and notes
table and a user table so let's go ahead
and create them notes table is
um
votes
and const
user table means user and these are like
table names as we define them here node
and user okay
so those are those and what else do we
need um i think i think that's pretty
much it to be honest with you i think
these are all the constants that are
needed in order for us to be able to
create our notes service
all right let's go ahead now and start
with our note server so i'm gonna clear
this go to the top of this file and then
i'm gonna make some empty space in here
and actually create our notes service so
let's go ahead and create a circuit
class here and call it node service
it's very exciting this is the beginning
of us creating a cross service that
works with our database which we're soon
going to create actually okay
as the cache indicates we need a
function an async function that opens
the database you see opening a database
is not a functionality that you can just
say open now it it will happen
asynchronously because we may need to
for instance grab the current um
current uh folder
do documents folder and then append or
join that documents folder with
our database name which we define here
as a console so it's a lot of
asynchronous stuff that we're going to
happen in there well not a lot but a few
at least
and that is the reason this open
function is going to be asynchronous
okay
so as i caption any case let's go ahead
and create a future void
and call it
just open
and we call it async like that
now this open function is going to keep
hold off
i mean after it has opened the database
is actually gonna
store it somewhere in our node service
so it's going to say hey i've opened the
database
here is the object so that other
functions in the future such as the
functions are going to let us
read
users from the database or you read
notes from the database those functions
then they're going to say ah oh here's
the database instance i know how to grab
values out of it okay so
what we're going to do is to say we have
a database
as you can see it is brought by our
sqflite
library
and we're just going to call it db all
right so
to begin with is null and we're going to
assign to it
all right um
so what should we do now um
let's go ahead then and start by doing a
test and see if this database is already
opened you see if we have an instance of
this database then we can kind of like
assume that this database file has
already been opened and we don't have to
open it anymore so let's just say if
the db
is not null
and just
throw
uh a new exception and we're gonna just
call it a database already open
exception so let's go and define an
exception
uh here
let me see if i can copy and paste that
from my notes
but you see this is just an exception
that's a database already open exception
all right so in here we're just going to
say database already open exception all
right
simple if you call the open function
multiple times while the database is
already open you're going to get an
exception okay so that kind of makes
sense
so let's go ahead and now get the
document
directory path and we have to do a try
in here
because this can actually throw an
exception so let's say find final
docs
path is equal to
and you need to say get documents get
application documents directory if you
have a look at the signature of this
method it says i return a future of
directory so let's go ahead and do that
so we need to await on it and that's the
reason our function is async and that's
the reason we're awaiting because this
returns the
path asynchronously now if you look at
the documentation for this you can see
that it can actually throw an exception
called missing platform directory
exception if the system is unable to
provide the directory
all right if for some reason this the
system isn't able to provide a document
directory to
um to us is going to throw this
exception and that is exactly why we
have our code inside a try statement
here so let's say if that exception is
thrown like this then we're going to
throw our own exception so let's define
an exception we call it unable to get
documents directory
this so it's just a class unable to get
exception nothing special about that
okay
and then we in here we say throw
at
uh
the name missing platform oh i see you
see it's it's complaining now and i can
see that you couldn't see the codes i
apologize for that it's complaining and
saying that i can't find this missing
platform directory exception and that is
because this is specified in this um
path provider but for our path provider
we just say show get
get application documents directory so
all other symbols are hidden from us so
we could just remove that and just
import the entire path provider and that
error goes away all right
okay
now let's do this now let's say
i apologize let's get the the actual
path of our
database so to do that you will say and
what are we calling it db path is equal
to join remember we have this function
joined here that we imported from path
and we say join
the docs path the path and our db name
remember the db name is a constant as a
string we define it down here we just
call the notes db
that is now going to be joined with the
actual path of our documents folder all
right
and what we're going to do
is we're going to say we now want to
open the database with a function called
open database which comes from
skflight
and the path is dbpath and remember this
open database i believe is the future of
our database you see so we await on it
all right
and
then we assign that to our uh local
database instance that's it
so that was basically
opening the database so we've now opened
it but
remember
all we've been working on right now is
inside this db browser for sqlite
this
thing this program here is managing its
own database file this database file is
not going to exist in your flutter
application we've just played around i
just showed you how to create a sqlite
database how to create different tables
what fields are what primary key is so
you need to kind of like forget about
this this application and where it
stores this data
you need to now focus on how is your
flutter application going to be able to
create those tables how is your flutter
application going to be re reading data
from the tables or deleting data from
the table so
if you think about it if you've
completely forgotten about the
db browser for sqlite then you could
just say at this point in time you see
open database also can create the
database for you if it doesn't exist
we can look at the documentation for it
here uh oh my god
opens the database at a given path by
the system
uh on is the first let's see encrypt is
called if the database did not exist
prior to calling opendatabase okay so it
can create the database for you which is
what it's gonna do but those tables are
not gonna exist and we have to have a
way of creating those tables if they
don't exist upon us opening the database
okay and that's what we're gonna do here
so let's go ahead and actually grab the
code for creating the user table so i'm
just going to say const create
user table is equal to and this is now
i'm going to actually use the syntax
that we haven't used before and that's
triple quotation marks okay
and then triple quotation marks on the
next line and then a semicolon now what
this does is that it allows you to place
pretty much anything inside this string
without you having to escape that string
because triple quotation marks are very
unique so if you paste any program other
programming languages code in here
chances are that programming languages
code is not going to include three
three quotation marks so the purpose of
this is that now you can go ahead in
your sqlite uh db browser for sqlite and
grab those users um if i go here
database structure user modify table and
you can literally now grab this code
that was created by a db browser for
sqlite and paste it in here you see
so there we go now you have a beautiful
database creation code in here sorry
table creation code that says create
table user blah blah id integer not null
and however we need to take care of
something in here and we just say if not
exists i believe
and we have to put it before user as
well so that's the only thing we're
adding here we're basically saying
create a table call user if it doesn't
exist because
you see we don't want to get an error
because if you create a table that
already exists in the database then
skflight is going to throw an error
saying that this table already exists
okay so that's why we need if not exists
and then what we need to do is to tell
our database this database that we
created up here to execute that command
so we're just going to say execute and
you see it says give me a sequel to
execute and i'm going to give you a
future void and we say okay execute
create user
table and we have wait on it
some comment in here we just say create
user table
and then in here for the um
after we've executed the create user
table we also have to then take care of
uh the creation of our note table
so i'm just going to do the same thing
that we did up here and just say create
note
table
equal to as single quotes triple
single quote semicolon let's go to db
browser for sqlite and grab this node
here and say modify table and grab the
code that was generated for you and just
paste it in here do some formatting so
it becomes a little bit more bearable to
read and have a look at and we do the
same thing that we did up there we say
if not exists like that all right
so
i think i think to be honest with you
we're good to go there i don't think we
need to do anything special in there we
also have to execute that command so i'm
just going to grab the code from there
paste it right here
and like that and i'm going to say
create note table so that's going to
do the creation of the note table as
well
well done that was it that was a big
function
i mean by the standards of what we've
done so far that was quite a big
function okay but generally this is not
considered such a big function i
remember now you have actually constants
in here you could you could i mean
if it's me deciding i would bring this
constant somewhere else not inside this
function we could literally go ahead i
mean i hadn't planned for this but let's
go ahead and grab this constant from
here and bring it to the end of this
file okay where we have all the other
constants like this
and let's go and grab the other constant
from here
boo
and bring it down as well so we put it
at the end of our file right there
okay
as i said i hadn't planned for this but
i just think it makes sense because now
our function is a lot cleaner to have a
look at here we have a comment for
create the user table let's create a
comment as well here we say
that creates notes table
and remove those empty spaces and just
save your file perfect
now we have the open function
let's go ahead and have a look at how we
can do closing of our database right
let's have a look at
my notes in here okay
let's have a look at our
closing code so i'm going to fold the
open function in here so we don't see it
anymore and let's go ahead and create as
you can see in the caption we have to
say future void close um okay and it's
asynchronous so
what we need to do then is we shouldn't
allow any person to close the database
if the database is not open so let's go
ahead and define an exception for that
and we're going to call the database is
not open okay so i'm going to copy that
exception so i don't have to type it
manually manually because by this point
you know how to create exceptions so
it's nothing extraordinary for you to
learn
database is not open that's a new
exception okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say
we have our database final db is equal
to our local db up there and we say if
db is null
and then we throw database not open oops
database
is not open
else we're gonna ask skflight to close
that database for us and the way to do
that is just to say db.close and you can
see it's a future of void so that's why
we're waiting on it all right
and then at that point we have to also
reset this local database which is
called underscore data underscore db so
we say db is equal to no
right so easy peasy close went very fast
actually
all right
now what we need you see as we're now as
we have to open and close now we're
going to start working with data in the
database but
in order for you to get
like your um
database so that it can for instance
actually grab
like every function that tries to read
something from the database it has to
have some code in order to make sure
that the database is open otherwise it
has to throw an error so we're gonna
have like five six of these functions
and each of which is gonna check the
database and then do the same thing is
the database open yes if it's not open
throw this error we could put that
particular code inside on our function
that we are going to call getdatabase or
throw okay so let's go ahead in here and
just say this function returns a
database
it database or throw
and
prefix it without underscore saying that
this is a private function and then
we're going to say final db is db
if db
is null
and we say throw um
database is not open
else
we return the db okay so this is a
private function that our reading and
writing internal functions in this class
are going to use in order to get the
current database so that they avoid
doing the same if statement everywhere
okay
all right now we're going to start with
actual code so
to read and write from the database in
this case we're gonna start with a
function called delete user that allows
us to provide as you can see an email
address
and using that email address then we're
gonna delete that user from our database
so you you will learn how to manipulate
data from our or inside our database
okay
so let's go ahead and do that function
signature as it's indicated here i'm
just going to say future void delete
user
and required uh string email
and make this function asynchronous okay
then
what we're gonna do is just to get our
database with this absolutely beautiful
get database or throw function that we
created here so i'm just going to say
final vb is get database or throw so
this in turn is going to throw an
exception called database it's not open
if the database is not open so we don't
have to
manually do that
okay so in order to delete something
from sql flight uh or in this case
sqlite that is managed by sqflight we
can say db dot
d b dot delete and as you can see it
returns a future of the number of rows
that were deleted and then it says okay
which table and then a where clause and
a list of objects to pass to your word
clause so we're going to say the delete
from the user table
and uh
the word clause is gonna be
email is equal to something
and the where arts are in this case are
gonna be email to lowercase okay so i'm
gonna put this
semicolon there and a call in here and
then we're going to wait on it and we're
going to say final
and delete the account is a weight
so in this case i mean as you can see
here is what we're basically doing is
just we're doing formatting we're going
to say we're going to say delete
something from the user table as long as
that something's email is equal to
something and that something is again
that email so you're basically saying
delete
as many objects as possible in the user
table as long as their email is equal to
this and remember we made email unique
so if if we've done our homework right
then deleted count is it should either
be zero meaning that no personal
account or no user with this email
exists in it into table or it should be
one meaning that yeah i could delete uh
without a problem
so
we're actually gonna assert that we're
gonna say if deleted count
is not
one
all right then we're gonna throw an
error could not delete the user so i'm
gonna grab that um exception i'm gonna
place it right here
so we say if we couldn't delete that
user we're just gonna say throw could
not delete user all right
so we couldn't delete that user
um
all right so let's go ahead
now that we have done the delete user
and and remember you may be asking okay
why are we throwing a user maybe that
user doesn't exist and it should just
work fine and of course i mean
it is going to work fine if you have
your try and catch statements when you
call this function
what we're saying is that the interface
of the node service is going to throw an
error through an exception if you call
the lead user with a non-existing email
and that's completely fine for a service
to do but where you're consuming the
service then you can manage and say oh
this delete function is going to throw
an exception by like for instance
looking at a documentation looking at
the code then i'm going to handle it
where i'm calling it as at the call site
which is called okay
so this is completely fine
for a service to do
then what we're going to do as the next
point is to create a user and you can
see
it's going to be a future of database
user so this is beautiful it's going to
actually create a user given an email
address and then it's going to return
that database user to us so let's go
ahead and do that let's just say
future
database user
and we're going to say create user
and a required string field of email
and we're going to make it asynchronous
all right
so in here what we're going to do is
just going to get the database we're
going to say final vb is equal to get db
database or throw
and then we're going to say um
db.query
um like that because we're going to
actually issue a query to the database
okay
so as you can see this is a helper to
query table and return items found all
optional clauses are unfiltered or
formatted as sql queries okay
so um let's go ahead and
in here what we're going to first do the
first thing we're going to encrypt user
now we're going to actually check if a
user with a given email already exists
okay and that's where why we're doing
query and we're not like inserting
something into the database to begin
with we're asking the data to say hey
does in the user table
we're looking for and we're acquiring
the database for a person or a user
whose email is this and that this thing
is actually going to return and let's
have a look at it it's going to return
a list of rows that were available in
the database okay and that list is going
to be empty if no
no entities matched our query okay so
let's just call it final results is
we're querying the user table
and we're going to say um
we're looking for
just one item
and we have a word equal to
we're looking for the email and where
arts are going to be
email to lowercase semicolon at the end
and bring it like this
equal to bb and we wait okay
so by us first
making a query to the database and
checking whether a user with the same
email exists we're basically avoiding
getting an error
for the uniqueness of that email later
on at the sql
layer
so in this case you can see results if i
move my mouse over it and it says that
it is a list of rows and if this list is
not empty
it literally means that a user with that
co without email address already exists
in the database so
let's then say if
results is not empty then we're going to
say throw
user already exists uh
exception and we don't have that
exception yet so let's go ahead and
find that exception for me at least and
i can paste it right here
so define this exception use already
exists
and let's go ahead and throw that
exception user already exists okay
so
that's the our if
statement so at that point we've
basically made sure that that user does
not exist in the database all right
so what we need to do then
is to go and insert that user now that
we've checked that he or she doesn't
exist in the database so we have to go
and insert that user so the way we do
that is by going and telling our
database we say db insert and you can
see it says in which table and then give
me a map of
keys and values which is the column name
and the value for that column all right
so let's just say we insert into the
user table
which is a constant we've defined from
before remember and then the map is
going to be
for the uh let's go back to our db
browser for sql for note sorry for user
uh oops
for user
we have id which is primary key not null
and auto increment so we don't have to
insert the id but we need to insert the
email so let's go ahead and say we have
the email call
is equal to b it's going to be equal to
email to lowercase all right
so like that and insert if you can have
a look here it returns a feature of pins
and if you read the documentation
uh let's see if if it gives us some
documentation here
zero could be returned for some specific
conflict algorithm algorithm algorithms
if not inserted so this is going to
basically give us that
uh
so what it's going to do in this case is
actually going to give us a user id back
i wish there was some good documentation
about it
oh here you can see it says insert
returns the id
so this is very very good this is
actually really cool because remember we
said we return a database user and a
database user actually has an id in it
so
if this function here did not return the
id how else would we get the id then
we'd have to insert and then read that
same user in order to get the id but we
don't have to do that so in here then we
say final
and we say user id is equal to await on
this function functionality
and then we just return a database user
up so you actually see the code then we
say user id and the email is email the
way it was before
they added a column there
fantastic now we've taken care of the
create user
uh
function in our database so that's
create user i'm gonna follow so now we
have create user delete user and open
and close and a private function in
order to get the current database
okay
as the caption indicates now we have to
take care of a function called get user
which it can retrieve a user given its
email address alright so
i'm going to go ahead and
basically write that function signature
in here by pasting it from my note so i
don't have to type it manually but you
have it in the captions in case you need
to go go to it we just like we did in
the other functions we're going to get
the current database or throw an error
if the database isn't open so we're
going to say db is get database or throw
then what we're going to do is we're
going to query the database for that
email address and if you remember in the
create user we already did that so let's
go and copy that
boof
like this
and i'm going to fold create user and
let's go in here and paste that code we
have the results okay
so in this case we have to do the
opposite you see in create user we
checked to make sure
that
um
the
results are actually empty because we
want to make sure before we create a new
user with that email that email doesn't
already exist but in this case we
actually have to do the opposite when
you want to get a user we want to make
sure that it does exist so we have to
say if results is empty meaning that we
couldn't find this user with the given
email address then we say a throw
could not find user
actually we don't have that yet so we
need to define a new exception called
could not find user and i'm gonna bring
it up here
just like we have to delete user we also
have could not find user okay and then
here we have to throw that could not
find user all right
if the results were empty then we throw
it up otherwise we have to then
construct a database a user so we say
return database user
from row and we say results
dot first
which is the first row that was read
from
the
user table also remember we set a limit
of one so it should be
it should be either zero
rows or one row which is the user with
the given email address okay
all right perfect uh let's go ahead to
the next function that we have to
implement and
that is for us to be able to create new
nodes so if you want to be like me and
like clean up the code a little bit here
just fold everything so you only see the
function signatures now we can focus on
the next function which is
creates nodes i'm just going to find it
in my notes here
just to make sure i give you the exact
code necessary in order to create the
create note function
uh if i can find it um creates notes
right there okay
as the
as the caption indicates we have to have
a an asynchronous function called create
node it returns a database node and it
also says who is the owner of this node
and it's just going to create a new node
with an empty text and it's going to
associate that and nodes with the given
database user and for you see the
parameter is of type database user and a
way to get a user is either to create
one if it doesn't exist and you get the
database user or you get an existing
user okay so
excuse me let's go ahead and say future
database user
and we call this function as the nodes
indicate create node and we say it's a
required field of a database user
oops sorry it shouldn't return a
database user it should be database
nodes all right and the parameter is the
owner which is the database user
and it's an async function
so just like we did in the other places
we're going to say final db is get
or throw
get the current database or throw
so what we need to do first is just to
make sure that the current user that we
are passing here already exists in the
database because remember database user
is just a class it can be created by
calling its constructor which is right
here um
somewhere here
so
i could just create a new database user
instance as a database user and a random
email and a random id
but in here when we're trying to create
a node for that particular database user
we need to first make sure that that
database user's actually inside the
database okay and to do that we say
final
bb user
equal to await
and we actually call our own get user
function in here we say get user with
the email of the um owner's email
on our email
so in here we're literally reusing the
code that we've created
then
what we're going to do is we're going to
check whether this database user is
actually the owner
see
what do i mean by that i mean that let's
say that i go and hack things up and i
say oh i create a new instance of
database user manually without inserting
into the database and here's the id some
sort of a random id and then here's the
email which i know exists in the
database
now what we need to do in our code is
just to make sure that the
id that you provided in your database
user here is actually an id of an
existing user in our database and to do
that we could literally use this little
beautiful function that we wrote earlier
which is the equality function of our
database user which actually checks our
id against the other
database user's id so if we literally
say here in here we say if the db user
is not the owner which goes into our
equal equal operator and negates it it
says oh if it's not equal to that then
we say throw
could not find user okay
so
after this place
if we if we actually found the db user
with that email and the id was exact id
as the owner then we can actually be
sure that that user does exist in the
database with the correct email and the
correct id okay so let's just put
comments here in here and say make sure
owner exists in the database with the
correct
id that's it okay
all right after we've done that we also
have to take care of actually creating
um
the note so let's go ahead and create a
um text and here we say the text is uh
i'm sorry i noticed that you couldn't
see that code
i hope that you saw this code at least
that i wrote here but if you didn't i
apologize for that because just because
i'm using a software that i don't see
the software all the time on my main
monitor which is the monitor i'm coding
i have to look at a secondary monitor
which is down here so i'm doing my best
to look at that secondary monitor just
to make sure you're seeing all the
content but sometimes i could miss that
i apologize for that so
let's see that
now you can see this code all right i'm
going to bring this code a little bit up
so let's go ahead and actually create
the notes so i'm going to put a comment
in here and say our work now is to
create notes create the notes
and what we're going to say we're going
to say
db insert just like we did an insert
previously for create user we're going
to
do a db insert for the notes and it's in
the notes table
and you see the values in here is going
to be a map
and the map is if you look at the
insert function is literally a map of
string and object so
let's have a look at our note table in
here and you can see notes right click
modify table it needs user id text and
is synced with cloud columns so let's go
ahead and say user id column user id
call
it's the owners id
and we had what else do we have we have
the text column
and that is equal to this text that we
just created out there which is an empty
text basically
you don't have to do this you don't have
to do that part you could just literally
just say
this
to me it's more readable if i define
these things beforehand like that okay
and then here we just say is synced
with
cloud column and its value is one in
this case so we're basically saying that
we start off with that okay
and i just noticed that i had missed a
column in there remember insert it
returns the id of the inserted object in
the database and it's a future so let's
then say final note id is equal to a
waiting on that function to insert the
notes into the note table
all right now that that is done we're
going to
actually return a new note instance and
return it a database note so what we're
going to do in here we're going to say
final
note is equal to database note
notes like that
and for the id we're going to say note
id i'm going to bring it up so you see
it better
and for the user id we're going to say
owner id text is text so this is another
reason to have it defined like a
constant like i did so that we can reuse
it here and there
and is synced with cloud what should we
do there we should probably just say
true okay
creating a note you have to return it
then inside your um asynchronous
function all right i'm going to put a
comma here as well just to make sure
formatting is in place
all right now we inserted notes into the
database and we also created a database
node to return that from our function
wow
a lot of code a lot of code but i hope
you're sticking with me throughout this
chapter so now we have create note
as the caption indicates now we have to
work on a function that allows us to
delete a node because remember we're
going to allow the user to select a node
in the database later sorry select the
node on the user interface which that
user themselves have created and be able
to delete that notes all right so we
need a function that allows us to delete
a node using its id all right
so
let's go i'm just going to bring the
basics of this function or almost the
entirety of this function actually here
so we don't have to code that manually
i'm going to paste it here
and as you can see here the signature of
this function i'm going to explain it
all the signature up to this function is
called delete node as an asynchronous
function as the caption at the bottom of
the screen in case we do the get db
and then we're literally just calling
the delete function which is the exact
same thing which i believe we did
in delete user let's have a look at that
you see delete count db delete in the
table
and then your work clause and in this
case inside the delete note we're saying
from the note table delete an object
which has its column id equal to
something and then we're passing that
something in the where arcs
now if we couldn't delete anything if
that note didn't exist with the given id
and we're throwing an exception called
could not delete node and that's an
exception that we haven't defined yet
and we're gonna have to define that at
the bottom all the other exceptions that
we've defined so far so that's could not
delete node implements exception all
right
so i thought to i mean i usually don't
copy paste code even if it's my own code
but i thought this is such an easy code
we have literally done every part of
something similar before we've done the
get db we've done the deletes before
we've done this if statement before so
it's nothing new and i don't think you
have to have
me here spending time explaining the
same thing over and over again and
that's why i copy pasted this delete
note here okay
all right then what we need also is the
ability for us to delete all nodes from
our database how do we do that as you
can see we need a function called future
means which is which indicates a number
of nodes that were deleted from the
database we call it delete
all nodes and it's an async function
here okay
and uh what we need to do in here is
just it's very simple we're going to say
final db is equal to get or throw
and then we say db delete and then we
just literally say uh
note oops note table
uh boom boom await on it all right
and you see
this if you issue the delete command on
on your database with a given table all
what it does is that it deletes every
row inside that uh table for you and it
will return the number of rows that were
affected so you can see it returns the
number of rows affected so that's
exactly what we want to return so just
return that value in this function right
perfect good stuff
we've done some big functions and some
small functions so it's so refreshing to
have some small functions as well
even for me so
so what we need to do now is to create
the functionality for fetching a
specific node you see when we actually
get to the ui where we render all the
nodes that are inside the database to
our user in the main ui of our
application we're going to list all the
nodes and then if the user presses on
any specific node then we're going to
get the id of that node and then read
that node's information from the
database and that's why we need a
function that takes an id of a node and
actually grabs that node for us from the
database okay
so let's go ahead and program that so
i'm gonna bring bring the uh
i'm gonna bring the
function signature and we're not gonna
copy paste it this time let me copy
paste the function actually i mean so
let's go ahead and get the db so this is
easy for you now you know how to do that
and we're going to query the database so
we're just going to say final notes
which is going to be like
the
iterable list of
maps that the sqlite database can read
so we're going to say await
on the db query
and we're going to say in the notes
table i'm going to remove all these
overlays so you see the code better
notes table and we're going to just say
um remit one because we want to get one
note all right
and the word clause is going to be
um using its id you see we're gonna say
id equal to something and the where arts
are gonna be just the id itself like
that boom and a semicolon like that all
right
and now if this notes uh
which is
you can see it's a list if notes
is empty we're going to throw an
exception so we're going to say um could
not find notes do we have that
uh could not find user we have could not
find notes we don't have so let's go and
define it
i'm going to bring it from
my own notes so we don't have to write
that manually
so define an exception called could not
find node implements exception all right
and then here we just throw it could not
find nodes so if you gave us an id we
couldn't find it in database we just
throw an exception otherwise
we need to actually create an instance
of our database node so we say return
database note from row and nodes first
okay so that's similar to how we did it
before for getting a user as well
all right now
we also need
a functionality that allows us to get
all nodes in the system you see we have
get node to delete all nodes delete node
create node but we don't have any
functionality that can get all the nodes
and that is the exact function we're
going to use the main interface of our
application to render all the nodes for
a given user okay
so
let me just make sure that i have that
function in here
and it is called
get all nodes
let's see
we can find a functionality get all
nodes somewhere
create note we have
get user we have
and perhaps i don't actually have a
functionality right now i can see in my
notes that i don't actually have get all
notes but that is actually not a problem
at all in the get note here you see we
have that we have to define this gets
all notes so let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to copy the signature of this
function
and i'm going to bring it here and we're
going to say we're going to return a
future
of list of database notes and we're
saying get
all notes like this all right excuse me
and it shouldn't require any parameters
we're just going to ask the database to
return all the notes all right
sorry about that again
and i'm going to copy the functionality
from here
for gets notes
excuse me again
and in here we're not now going to limit
anything and we don't have anywhere
clause okay so just like that we're
going to say db query from the note
table and we get all the notes then if
notes is empty then we say could not
find notes
or perhaps we could just say
notes we can see it's a list we can
literally
not have any special logic in here that
says could not find note or anything
and i'm gonna have a look at my notes in
here
that's fine um
what we need to do now now that we have
our notes we can map them so we say
notes map and you can name this
parameter and and in your mapping you
need to say okay i get a database note
which which you can see is of type let
me see if i can move my mouse over here
it's a map of string object this matches
perfectly into our database notes
but from row and then you say from this
n
let's actually call it note row or
something like that and we put it there
and if you say final
result
and now i think this is an eye treble to
be honest with you so you can see it's
an iterable of database notes okay so
what we could do is actually change our
future in here instead of saying list we
return on iturble okay so
in order for the sake of uh cleanliness
i'm also gonna change our captioning
here and say iterable so you see the
correct information on your screen as
well
all right
so that's our result so all we need to
do in here just to return it that's it
so so
like that
perfect so
um and that's the functionality of get
all nodes so it's very simple nothing
nothing special
and
now uh what we need to do is just to
wrap it up there's one last function
that we have to implement and remember
when we go to the main ui of the
application we're going to allow the
user to create nodes list all their
created nodes and also be able to click
on any specific node in order to update
the contents of that node so we need a
function called update note so let's go
and bring my notes in here update notes
so let's go ahead and create the
signature for that function and future
database notes
and we say update notes
like that and we're going to have some
required parameters which we actually
grab an existing database note object
and then we
expect the user to also provide a new
text so let's just say required
a database note
notes and then we say it's the required
string of text just like that
you're already familiar with this we're
gonna get the database we say get or
throw
okay
and we're just gonna issue an update to
our
database we haven't done updates before
for our sql like database so that's what
we're going to do now so let's just say
db.update
and you can see it says give us a table
or give me the table and
your list of updates so let's go in here
and say
update the uh
note table
um
and actually before doing that how do we
make sure that this table that note
already exists in the database because
like we saw earlier anybody can go and
add
or create an instance of a database node
it doesn't necessarily have to be in the
database but we kind of need to make
sure that it already is stored in the
database because before we can updates
to update its text so we already have a
functionality that does that remember
gets notes with an id so we could
literally just say
await
it's note
and then we say note id
and you see this actually throws an
error
if you go to this function it throws an
error called could not find note which
is exactly what we're after but we're
not actually after the the result of it
we don't want the actual note because
we're assuming that that is the same
object as this so we're just ignoring
its return value okay
in the update we're going to say the
notes table
and the values that we're going to
provide are two we're going to say the
text column
i need a new text
and we're upon you updating the text of
a node we're also going to assume that
well all of a sudden this node is not
synced with the back end or with the
data with the
uh with the cloud database anymore okay
so that goes back to our um
async with cloud column
so let's go in here and say is synced
with cloud column then it's going to be
set to zero remember that was an integer
field all right update is an
asynchronous function so you have the
weight on it
and it also returns the number of feel a
number of rows that were updated so
we're going to say updated
updates count
sorry
final
updates count is equal to a weight on db
update all right now by you
at the call side calling the updates
note function we're assuming that that
note should have existed
in the database okay so in this case the
updates count should it should be a
value other than zero okay so we say if
updates count is equal to zero
bring the code up so you can see it
and then we have to throw a new
exception called could not update
note and paste that
exception from my notes
so it should look like this class could
not update node implements exception all
right so i need you to write this code
as well
and if updates notes
if updates count is zero then we're
gonna say throw could not update
note
else
now you can see what we promised is to
return a new database note so let's go
and just say
do we then i mean that's that's the
thing we've updated that uh and how do
we return an update a database note to
you well we could just do this
turn
its uh notes with that note id because
we already have gets notes function
implemented all right
wow
very well done if you could stick with
me throughout this chapter because we
did a lot of work so um i'm gonna fold
this fold this you can see we have a lot
of functions here
quite a lot of work and i think so far
this has been the biggest chapter of
this uh of this course but we've also
had a lot to do a lot of information i
hope you could stick with me
let's go ahead now and clean up our
exceptions as the caption indicates
let's put all our crowd exceptions in
one file inside lib services crowd crud
underscore quad exceptions okay
so let's go in here and
uh actually it should say crowd slash
crowd exceptions so um if i look at my
notes inside services crud i'm gonna
fix this caption and i apologize for
that i'm just gonna fix it on on the go
like this and i'm gonna bring it up
and actually it should say crowd slash
crud underscore exception so i think
there was more than one error in there
and cros
required exceptions so
it should be lip services slash quad
exceptions all right so let's go and fix
that up
inside services we have crowd already
and we have nodes service dart let's
create a new file in there and we just
call it crud exceptions dot art now i
need you to go into your node service
dart file and grab all those exceptions
that you define here and just cut them
with command x on macintosh or control x
in linux and windows and then bring it
into your quad exceptions alright and
save this file
and let me also have a look here
just to make sure my notes are clean as
well for you
uh so because i i noticed that the next
caption was also a little bit incorrect
now we need to go and use that crowd
exceptions in our note series because as
you can see it is marked as red right
now because there were so many
exceptions thrown that um this file
doesn't have access to anymore so i'm
gonna get help from visual studio code
here with command dot and say import
crowd exceptions
and all those errors are gonna go away
all right well done huge chapter a lot
of work done and congratulations for
sticking with me through this chapter
now as is the tradition we're gonna now
go ahead and commit our work and um also
tag it so i'm going to make the screen a
little bit bigger
let's go to our terminal here
and i'm then going to say in here we're
going to tag and commit our work as step
11 so let's first get status
and then we say git add all
hit status again here are the things
we've done pop spec was changed because
we added three dependencies uh provide a
path provider path
and and also i believe actually it was
called path and path provider right
yes
path path provider and sqlite so that's
why these two files have been changed
node service is completely new and crowd
exceptions is also new
so git commit
uh step 11 as the caption indicates um
git push
which they commit first remember and
then we tag it as step 11
and we push our tags as
well fantastic
now congratulations again for going
through this chapter with me it was a
huge chapter i think the biggest so far
now we need to get ready for the next
chapter as a tradition for the other
chapters at the end we talk a little bit
about what we're going to do in the next
chapter just to get ready for it
so
we've done a lot of work on the data now
we need to fuse it together with our uh
with our ui and in order to do that we
need to talk about streams and stream
controllers you see
when you're in the main ui of your
application after you've logged in you
need to see a list of your notes
but what happens if you see the list of
your notes and then you press the plus
button to create a new note and this
plus button is a button that we're going
to create soon in the next chapters what
happens if you press the plus button
should you then send manually a signal
to your ui and say hey a new note was
created update the list that is a lot of
work and for that you can do things a
lot cleaner if you use streams and
stream controllers and that's what we're
going to talk about in the next chapter
so
you may want to have a short pause after
this chapter since it was so big so do
that please get your refreshments coffee
tea whatever you want and i'll see you
in the next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 28
of the swata course in previous chapters
we've been talking quite a lot about
crud create read update delete and we
talked about how we can for instance
have raw functionality in our node
service so that we can read from the
database delete stuff from the database
create users etc etc now we haven't
really worked in the past two chapters
so much with our user interface and
that's completely okay because sometimes
as you're developing applications or
you're developing software you may have
to take detours in order to create the
functionality that is later gonna be
needed
for your user interface and you'll do
the same thing if you're doing um
back-end development like uh web
development so i myself do web
development with django and sometimes i
have to go and create a lot of
functionality on the backend first
before i can actually go and mirror that
functionality on the ui which is for
instance the web browser where the user
is consuming the content so
and
if even if you're a designer for
instance you're working with figma you
can't always produce user-facing content
like prototypes you may have to
sometimes go and design for sure
components and then after you've done
your components and you'll be ready to
put those components into screens and
display that to your product owner or
your developers
so
um
so far we've been working a lot with
what the user doesn't see and we have to
like stitch
up those last bits and pieces before we
can actually go to the ui and manipulate
that data which our notes service can
right now manipulate we're missing a few
functionalities which we're going to
develop in this chapter in the node
service
and
what we're going to work with in this
chapter especially is with streams and
stream controllers so
let me bring up the caption
that i'm going to talk about now so what
are streams and what are stream
controllers well
if you are a developer already you've
done software development you may know
something uh
about reactive programming and reactive
programming is where you have
a bunch of data sitting somewhere for
instance and then you perform some
operations on that data and this data
gets updated and you will be notified of
these updates through some sort of a
pipe of information so
and if you haven't done software
development before so reactive
programming and streams and stream
controls may be a little bit
overwhelming but we're going to start
very slow so there's nothing to be
worried about i'm going to explain
everything as much as i can to make
things easier for you
but if you don't have development
background from before software
engineering background there's not so
much that i can explain about streams
and stream controllers for you to
completely understand how they work all
i can say is that imagine a stream is
just a point of time or a stream is
basically an entity that controls data
all right just say something that keeps
hold of data and then you perform things
on it so you say add this data or remove
this data add this data with this data
and give me the results so
it keeps hold of its data and it has a
timeline so it starts at some point
manipulates its data and then it either
errors out at the end saying that oops i
can't do this and then it just dies or
it will just complete at some point and
also there is a third category of
streams
where the data just keeps living on so
it never basically
um
completes or
errors out so
so just think of streams as pipes of
data types of information that you can
manipulate and you can also perform
operations on
so if that's what streams are then what
are streams stream controllers in dart a
stream controller is your interface
um to your streams so
you have the stream which is sitting
right here and you can't
you you don't basically usually go and
add stuff to a stream directly or read
stuff from the stream what you can do is
to have a stream controller where you're
manipulating the stream for instance our
node service and this stream controller
is able to for instance add stuff to the
stream or read stuff from the stream so
just imagine the stream controller is
kind of like the manager of that stream
so if all of this sounds a little bit um
high level and abstract i completely
understand that it usually is when
you're working with reactive programming
some people actually hate reactive
programming but
as one of my colleagues used to say it's
always easier to
hate than to learn and my approach is
usually if i hate something is because
maybe i haven't really fully understood
it so there are very few things in my
life that i've actually learned which i
hated after learning so
if you're a bit overwhelmed by streams
and stream controllers or reactive
programming don't be they're actually
really good if you know how to use them
so they're very easy to use as long as
you get a handle of uh
how basically it's getting a handle of
the right way of using them so that's
what i'm going to show you in this
chapter and then
upcoming chapters as well
so let's go excuse me let's go to our
application i'm going to put the code
right here let's have a look at what
we've written so far i'm going to
increase the size of the screen and then
decrease the font size a little bit so
it's not as ginormous
so
um
let's have a look at what we've done so
far you can see we have quite a lot of
functionality in here
we have for instance delete all nodes
then we have
get all nodes
we have update nodes so quite a lot of
functions
but if you see all of these are directly
talking with our database with our
sqlite database none of these
functionalities are
actually telling or
we don't even have to talk about
functions but if you look at the node
service in it itself it doesn't contain
a list of nodes so it doesn't have the
ability to cache these nodes so it's as
soon as you give it a command the node
services i don't know what to do i'm
just going to go to the database and do
what you said i have to do
however this could i mean in not in our
application but in an application that
has millions and millions of rows of
data for instance this could not be such
a good idea that you always go to the
database and
read the entire thing in order to for
instance delete one row or um basically
these operations should kind of be like
cached inside your application before
you go and hit the database hopefully
and what we're going to do as you can
see in the caption here we're going to
actually start caching a list of notes
that the node service has so the goal is
for the note servers to be able to
expose a list of notes that the ui can
then render on this on the user screen
so if the user goes and presses the plus
button then that plus button is then
gonna send a message here to our note
servers we're going to then go to this
function create node and this create
node function internally is then going
to manipulate that list of nodes inside
node service say hey here's a new node
add that
and then our ui is going to listen to a
list of these notes available in note
service and if things change in that
list
then the ui is just going to
automatically update itself and this
interface between the ui and the node
servers is going to be done through a
stream okay
i know it's a lot of a lot of
information but you'll get it you'll get
it as long as we go through this chapter
together
so what we need to do first is let's go
and as then as the caption at the bottom
of the screen indicates we're going to
go and expose a list of notes in our
note service okay so let's just let's go
ahead and say we have a list
of uh database notes
and we're just gonna call it notes and
we're gonna start with an empty list all
right
so that's really good now we have let's
say this is our cache this is where
we're keeping all the notes that this
node service manipulates all right
so now let's go and talk a little bit
about our um
stream controller so
you see what we need to do as the as the
information here says um
what we need is for the node service to
be able to control a stream of nodes so
when the list of this nodes changes we
need to
tell our stream in the note servers that
hey some element got added hey some
element got deleted or some element got
updated so
then the ui can then reactively listen
for these changes in the in the nodes
service and we do that through the um
our stream controller
so let's go as the caption indicates i'm
going to write it and notes actually
maybe i should yeah i'm going to write
it notes stream controller and the way
to create a stream controller is that
you just say stream controller and then
you specify the type of data that your
stream contains which is a list of
database nodes
and then we're gonna
just say dot broadcast
like that and i believe stream
controller isn't yet
excuse me um isn't imported in our notes
service so i'm gonna get help from
visual studio code and you can see it's
it says that well stream controller is
available in the dart async package so
um and yeah async meaning asynchronous
so in order to be able to use stream
controller you have to import that so
i'm going to get help from visual studio
code to do that
all right so let's see what we did in
here
what is this the syntax looks really
really scary but it really isn't all
you're saying is that i want to be able
to control a stream
um
of a list of database notes basically
you're saying that i have a pipe this
pipe
every event that is inside this pipe is
a list of database nodes so let's say
you start with an empty list so this
list is empty inside this pipe then you
add an item to this
pipe
then what it does it says oh what was i
before i was on empty list add that new
item so now i'm an item now i'm an array
or a list with one item and then it puts
that array inside the stream so the
stream's value is now at the beginning
was empty list then it's a list of one
item so this stream controller is
basically in in control of as its name
indicates it's in control of the changes
to this notes um
list it isn't hooked to that yet but
that's its purpose and that's the reason
it has the exact same data type in its
stream controller
now the broadcast part in here and as
you can see the documentation actually
spot on it says the controller where
stream can be listened to more than once
and
if you've done dark development or
flutter development from before you may
know that if you then um and i'm now
assuming as i said that your dart or
flutter developer from before if you
have created a stream controller and
then you go and listen to the changes to
that stream that the stream controller
is controlling and then you do a hot
reload then you get an error from your
flower application saying that oh this
stream's already been listened to so you
cannot listen to it again and that's the
problem that normal stream controllers
can cause and that you as soon as you've
listened to them you should close your
listening channel to that stream before
you can listen to them again so that's
what broadcast fixes if you're not a
developer from before what this
broadcast basically is saying is that
it's okay for you to create new
listeners that listen to the changes to
this stream controller so here's a pipe
of information at this point you start
and listen and then it's completely okay
that if you want to listen to changes to
the stream controller later in the
future as well so you're not going to
get any errors by doing this broadcast
all right
all right um
now what we need also is a
handy function
in our um
in our application.can
that can read all the available notes
from our database and then cache them
inside both the notes cache right here
and our controller okay
so you see what our our goal in this
chapter is is to
make sure that this is the source of
truth that our notes
list contains all the nodes for
for instance the current user
then the stream controller
is our interface to the outside world
the ui is going to be listening to
changes that occur in this stream
controller
so whenever you see this this is not
something that's going to be read from
the outside
everything's going to be read from the
outside through this all right so keep
that in mind so let's go ahead as a
caption in the case and we're going to
create a function in here called cache
notes and its purpose is just to read
all the notes from the database and
place it both in here internally and in
our node stream controller which is
going to be read externally all right
so let's go and do that so i'm going to
say future void and we're going to call
it cache and notes
is async
then if you remember we already have an
async function called get all notes so
i'm just going to say um final uh all
notes is await
it's all notes okay so that's gonna get
all our notes
and we're gonna assign that to our uh
list of notes in here okay
so let's go in here and say
as you remember get all notes returns on
iterable of all our notes and now we
have a little bit of a problem here
because we're saying list of all notes
and in here we're also saying list of
notes so we have to convert that
terrible to a list of all notes okay
either we could do that or we could have
this just sit there as an eye treble
it's completely up to you i have no
issue with any and we could just go with
list
so let's go in here and then we're gonna
say uh our notes
is the private notes is all notes to
list
and we also are going to update our
stream controller with that with the
value of underscore nodes okay so we're
going to say notes stream controller
if i can spell
and then we're going to add
notes to the stream and remember a
stream is just
the evolution of a value through time
and
the first point of this evolution was an
empty list and then the next one is
going to be
the
notes that are all the notes are in the
database okay so that's just
that we telling anyone listening to the
stream controller that hey here's a new
value all right
okay so um
now that we're doing this you can see
we're getting an error and dart is very
actually this analyzes so clever because
you see it's telling us that the cache
notes function is not being used now
you may be asking yourself well none of
these functions are being used update
note for instance is not being used so
if i
search for update notes
let's see update
nodes could not update nodes so yeah you
can see that update node function in
itself is not being used at all so
why is it that the
analyzer is complaining about this
function particularly and the reason is
because we have a little prefix
behind this function name
and this prefix is telling
the analyzer that this function is
private and private to this class now
dart analyzer is looking at it and it's
like okay it's a private class but
you're not using it so
the reason that other functions aren't
being um
marked with this warning is that dart
understands that they are not prefixed
with a
with a with an underscore meaning that
they're going to be used publicly
somewhere else so it's not going to yet
give us any warning saying that you
haven't used those functions as soon as
you remove that you see that the warning
also goes away but we're going to keep
down the score okay i just want to
explain to you why you're seeing this a
little warning here
okay now that we've done cash notes what
we're going to do is just to go to our
as a caption case we're going to go to
the open function
let's see if we can find it
here
open
and upon opening our database so uh let
me have a look at my notes
upon opening our database we are going
to um
cache all those uh
let's let me just have a look at my
notes yeah we're gonna basically go to
uh
the open function that we have here
future void open
i'm a bit surprised that i actually
haven't
written any notes about that yeah i can
see actually i have so that's good okay
so
right after executing this command for
creating the notes table after we've
created the user table and note table
and now that we know that we could open
the database we also have to cache all
the notes in our
local variable so let's just go and call
that function so we're just going to say
await cache
notes okay
so this means that when you call this
open function
if after we made sure all the tables
everything is there
if they didn't exist then we're gonna
read all the notes and place them inside
this notes variable and also in this
stream controller okay so that's how we
did the cache notes and i hope that you
could see the see the code
and it wasn't hidden by the caption at
the bottom of the screen
all right so that part is done now um
now what we need to do in here is to go
to the next part of the code and as you
can see it says cache note in create
node in create node function add the new
node to underscore nodes and the node
stream controller
so
i'm going to go to my nodes here creates
nodes
and ensure that when we create the nodes
in our creates node
right here in this function in the
create node you see at the moment what
we're doing is that we're just creating
a node and returning it
that's good but i mean it's not good
enough because as i said we need the ui
to be able to reactively listen to all
the notes that are right now in the
database for that current user okay
so in here after we create the note
we're actually going to add it to our
array of nodes and then we're also going
to add it to
our stream controller so i'm just going
to go in here and say nodes
and add this new node in there and also
remember the stream controller's
responsibilities just reflect the values
inside the underscore nodes to the
outside world so all we have to do is
just to say notes stream controller add
notes just like that because notes is
the source of truth as i mentioned
before all right
great stuff uh
now we need to take care of the other
function called delete note let's
search for that
um
delete notes all right so
what we need to do is to have a look at
this uh functionality here and you can
see it says if we couldn't delete
anything then uh throw this
exception but now we're gonna add an
else statement in here and
by us being able to delete that note
meaning that you can see the note id we
have which is this id so what we need to
do as a caption in the case we need to
actually remove that note also from our
local cache so we're going to say notes
remove where
and this is the note and then i'm going
to say note that id
should be equal to that id
after doing that we could just say note
stream controller add
notes and you could be try you could try
to be clever in here and you for
instance could say oh
you see that
who says that that note actually exists
in our cache we can't 100 be sure about
that but if you look at the signature of
the remove where function
um removes all objects oh maybe we don't
have the ability to actually know
if that node was deleted but what you
could do you could just say count before
is notes count and then you could in
here or length
and here you could just say if notes
links
is not count before then you can update
your stream i don't plan to do that but
you can you can try to do that if you
want to it's just a safeguard for you to
say i'm gonna update my out outside
facing stream only if i actually could
delete this note from my cache
if you think it's worth it i don't think
it's worth it
but that's just an opinion
so we're going to leave it like this as
the caption also indicates
now you see we also have a functionality
to delete all nodes so
let me find that function
all nodes
all right so let's go in our delete
all nodes in here find that function and
you can see right now what it what it's
doing is just returning the number of
deleted nodes
now what we're going to do we're going
to say final uh
what should we call it number of
deletions
is equal to this and we're gonna return
that number of deletions okay because i
mean i'm doing that simply because we
need to
do some work in in the middle here okay
so then what we're gonna do is gonna say
notes
is an empty list all right so we're
resetting the notes and then after doing
that we're also going to update our
stream controller so we're going to say
add the underscore nodes to stream
control and then return the number of
deletions so let's make sure that our
local cache is updated and also that the
user-facing
interface of our class which is the
stream controller is also
updated with the latest information
okay next thing that we need to do as
you can see in the cache that says
update caching get node remove old node
with same id and add the new one on and
update this stream so
let's go to our git node
okay
so um
let's have a look at our get note in
here then
and at the moment as you can see in here
what it's doing is
oops that's not get note um here is get
note
right there
okay
and as you can see here uh we're
basically what we're doing is that we're
saying um
upon you trying to read a note from the
database we're literally just making a
query to the database and then if we
could find that item we are returning it
by creating a database node from
from a row that you can see right here
uh but what we're gonna do is that if
you try to get a note in there is a
possibility that we already had that
note cached locally in our notes array
but that note is
uh outdated meaning that the copy that
we had in our cache is not really
updated with the latest changes that
have been applied to the database so it
makes good sense right here to now upon
creating a new instance of database node
actually to update our local cache as
well okay so i'm just going to say final
note is equal to that and we're going to
return that node
bill right here so this code is the
exact same as it was before except we're
now assigning the return value of from
row to a new local variable here okay
so let's go to our notes and say remove
where
and i'm going to say in here note and
i'm going to say i'm going to say note
id should be equal to id
which is
this thing here okay so we first remove
that node existing node from the notes
array then we say nodes add
and we add the new nodes in there and
then what we're going to do is right
after that update the stream controller
which is our outside facing um interface
so note stream controller add notes okay
so you can see this pattern so we first
always update our local cache and then
we reflect those changes to the outside
world all right
all right great stuff so um
that's for note stream controller and
notes um
[Music]
now there's another function which is
called update notes and
let's go to update node actually before
we have a look at anything else and you
can see in here when we update that
first we make sure that that node exists
so let's put actually a comment in here
make sure note exists
and then we say
update db i'm going to expand this code
so you see better that's the update db
part
and if we couldn't update anything then
we throw it could not update note and
you can see that in here
upon doing an update node what we want
to do is i mean it is quite clever what
we've done so far because it means that
we've updated the database but what we
do then in order to return the new
refresh node is that actually we call
getsnow so
that is that's pretty good so
but what we also need to do is just to
make sure our local and cache is also
updated
so
let's go in here and say final
updated nodes
and what we're going to do as the
caption at the bottom of the screen
indicates we're going to remove that
notes from our local cache and add the
updated note in there and then
send the add message to our stream
controller as well so let's just say
notes
and remove
so we're going to remove the old object
from our cache and i'm just going to say
notes
as long as the notes id is equal to the
updated notes id so that's going to
remove the existing existing node
and i'm going to say notes add and we
have the
updated node in here
as soon as you change your
notes and local cache then you need to
also update your stream so the stream
controller add
notes
all right
and then we return the updated notes in
here so what happening here is just that
we updated something in the database we
got the new object from uh the database
we removed that uh node from a local
cache and then we added it in there okay
added it back that's the updated node
all right
all right great stuff that's for update
notes and then what we need is as the
captioning case is get or create user in
node service
so um
this is a function that we're going to
actually use in the next chapter
um
so
how is this function useful this is the
first time we're actually seeing the the
um
signature for this function as the name
in the case it says get or create user
you see
when you at the moment go into our user
interface let's go to the login view for
instance
login view here
i'm gonna remove the explorer so you see
the code in its entirety and right here
when we do auth service firebase login
then we get the current user if the
email is verified is that we're going to
nodes routes now let's then go to our
notes view you can see right now notes
view the only thing it's doing is that
it's creating an app bar with a um sorry
it's creating a scaffold with an app bar
that we have our logout button in
and let's go actually let me bring up
scr cpy so i'm gonna use my email
address in the login screen so um
i actually may need to go and
connect this device to wi-fi so boom
i'm gonna open up um
that login with my user so i'm to get
rid of all those
i'm going to login in here use oops uh
we've sent you an email verification
okay
maybe i should actually log in with the
user who has already been verified
so let's log in with this user you see
in the main ui of the application um of
our application we have this hello world
right there because
um you can see the body of the
the body of our notes view right now it
just says hello world so you could
pretty much say that the notes view has
literally no contact at the moment with
the notes service
but we're gonna fix this soon by first
making sure that the note service allows
the user interface to
create a new user upon going to the
screen so when we come to the screen we
need to make sure that there is a user
associated with the current firebase
user
inside our database okay
so that's what we need this little uh
good function called get or create user
which returns a database user in our
notes service so we're gonna use that in
the next chapter so remember that okay
but we need to create the function at
this right now
all right let's go then and create this
function as the name indicates so future
and database user and we're going to say
get or create user and it has a required
parameter i can see required stream
email
and it's an async function right
so um
we need to basically have a look at this
how we can create this user
so
the goal in here is to first we try to
get this user from the database if that
user doesn't exist then we're going to
create that user and then in both cases
we're going to return either the
fetched or the created user back to
the
caller
so let's go in here and just say
final
user is await
get user okay and you see the email just
fits in there perfectly but if you
remember from the implementation of get
user let's go in there and expand this
if
the user couldn't be found then it
throws an error says could not find user
that's rq so that if that function
throws that error then we're going to
create that user so if that user doesn't
exist in the database it needs to be
created so let's put a try statement in
here and then we're going to say on
could not find user
so here is
the user so in this case in the try
statement it means that we could get the
user okay so if we get to this return
statement it means that get user
function didn't throw any exceptions
such as could not find user in the case
that we could not find user we're going
to actually create a user so let's just
say created user
is a way to create user
with that email and then we're gonna say
return created user and if you look at
the create user function as well right
here it also i believe does it throw yes
so if it couldn't create that user it if
it's the result was empty it just says
user oh no that's that's where we get
the user sorry about that
we need to have a look at this insert so
yeah that's the only thing it's doing so
it's not basically throwing any other
error okay
the only thing it does is if you're
creating a user that already exists i'm
going to draw an error
so here
we have where and we've ended up with a
try and catch block
that could also throw an exception which
we haven't handled all right so what you
could do is just to do a whole catch in
here and then don't do anything with it
i like this pattern quite a lot in my
code at least because if i don't do this
then i don't actually have the
possibility to debug my application
later so i can't put like a breakpoint
in here and see did any other exception
arise if you don't do that because then
the exception will be thrown to
the caller and the caller will have to
handle that but in this case we're not
really handling the exception we're just
catching it and then we're throwing it
back to the call side this only allows
you basically to put a breakpoint in
here if you want to debug your
application later okay so it's just a
it's just in quite a cheap way of making
your code easier to debug all right for
those of you who are interested in this
all right fantastic and we've covered a
lot and
there's still a lot to do
but we've come far so congratulations um
let's have a look here it says let's get
ready for the next chapter and upon
logging in we need to call our get or
create user function and have the user
ready
and this is what i mentioned to you
before inside our notes view at the
moment
we don't have any functionality that
creates
a new user or gets the current user
based on their email if they already
exist in the database and
that is going to be like the actual uh
first bit of logic which we're gonna do
in the next chapter which integrates our
notes view with the note server so the
tempo
of our course right now is gonna shift
towards more and more to the notes view
until we have a list of notes and allow
the user to create notes update notes so
it's exciting times we've come far we've
done quite a lot of work up up to this
point um and there's still a lot left
but um
hopefully you're getting the attack at
that like the
tempo of the uh
of the course better and better and you
can see
why we are doing things the way we are
doing so
uh congratulations again
and uh
get some refreshments if you want to
again coffee tea and i'll see you in the
next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 29
of this flutter course in the previous
chapter as you saw we worked with our
note servers and we talked about streams
and stream controllers
we have put uh you know a lot of effort
in our note service in order to talk
with the database and kind of read from
the database and cache
the red information
in our notes uh member variable so if
you haven't watched the previous chapter
i highly suggest that you do that
because
moving forward with this course without
having watched his chapters
chronologically makes it quite difficult
for you to proceed so
i'm gonna build on top of the previous
chapter as we've done with the other
chapters as well and in this chapter
we're gonna basically start putting in
place uh all the structure necessary in
in order for
us to be able to display all the user
generated notes
in the notes view okay
so as you can see we have almost
everything in place um there are a few
functions left to do and we also in this
video in this chapter we're going to
talk about future builder and also a
stream builder
and i don't think we've talked about
stream builder before we talked about
future builder so that's going to be an
exciting um
new thing to talk about in this chapter
all right so
i've just i've talked about this in the
um
in the outro to the previous chapter
that what we need to do in this
chapter right now in chapter 29 is to
allow the user to to go to the notes
view and upon going to the note c we're
all always going to make sure that that
user exists in our database now you see
we have firebase right here and then our
user has upon coming to the notes view
that user must have logged in with a
verified email address so that user
exists we know that that user exists in
firebase and has a verified email
address but that user might not exist in
our database remember we're gonna store
the user generated notes in our database
and hook them to the user who created
those notes okay so
um so upon going to the notes view we
always need to make sure that that user
exists in the database
and the way to do that if you remember
let me just bring the code you don't
have to try to remember that so let's go
into our notes service you can see
we have a function called get all notes
and but we don't have any functionality
at the moment to for instance give us
the notes for a a specific user so
if we want to do that if you want to for
instance get grab all the notes for a
specific user then we're going to go
with a user's email address because if
you look at the way our application is
working with um
the current user you can see we're
working always with officer so we're not
going through um firebase directly and
our auth service also has an off user so
let's have a look at our auth and have a
look at auth user and you'll see that
our auth user only has one flag that
just says is email verified
so how do we go and call this function
which is called get or create user on
our note service where we don't actually
have an email address for our current
user
and that's what we need to do we need to
go ahead and add an email field to our
off user
and so as the caption indicates here we
need to add this field to our off user
okay so i'm going to change the screen
layout a little bit so you see better
and let's go ahead and add a new field
in there i'm going to have a look at my
notes also um or user
so and add a new field in here and we
just call it the final
string um email
just like that and get help from your
editor in order to add the email field
add final field here so this is also
going to be a required parameter like
this and i'm just going to make it
required like this and it come at the
end to get the formatting done
and here where we actually creating our
instance of auth user what we're going
to do is to say we return an auth user
and the email is already actually in the
firebase user let's go to the firebase
user and look for email you see there is
a getter called email okay
and the thing is that this email getter
is optional string so what we need to do
is just to make it optional maybe in our
off user as well okay so in here then
where we create the off user we're just
going to say the email field is equal to
user email and put a comma at the end
here and a comma here as well to get the
format going
so all we did in here would say that our
r auth user has an optional string as
its email and that email string is read
from the firebase user that's all
nothing complicated
all right
okay what we need to do then is to as
the caption indicates go to our notes
view and grab the let's go notes view
here and we need to then read the
current user's email address okay so
what we're gonna do is saying that our
auth user has an optional email but we
we as an application developer are sure
that because we're using email and
password registration we are sure that
any user who ends up in the notes view
has an email address okay so
that's an assumption we're going to make
although our off
user which was let's see if we can find
it
off user here although the off user says
that i optionally have an email but
we're always going to say no that email
should exist because we're only at the
moment using email password sign in
method all right so
in order for this notes view to be able
to make a call to the notes service and
grab
or sorry to create or get the current
user it needs an email so let's go ahead
and expose a functionality in our notes
view
as the caption indicates that grabs the
user's email so let's go in here and i'm
going to go to my notes view as well in
my notes
all right
and what we're going to do in there is
just to expose the user email so let's
just say
string get user email
let's get rid of this side
explorer as well
and i'm going to say off service
firebase
all right off service i don't think it's
imported so let's actually see is it
imported
off service yeah it is imported okay
that's good
about firebase
and this can't be equal so that's why
it's going a little bit crazy firebase
and then we're going to say current user
and you see this current user is now
optional but since we are the
application developer and we're sure
that if you end up in the notes view
then you should have a current user
that's what we've already made sure in
the previous steps okay so if you look
at the
login screen for instance in our login
view so i open the login view here we're
saying if the current user exists and is
email verified is true then go to the
notes view so
then we can be sure that inside the
notes view we already have a user okay
so
this current user in firebase currently
says optional but we're gonna unwrap it
force on rapid okay and then we're gonna
say email and force unwrap that too
all right so um
that's what we've done so now we get the
user's email
now if you remember inside our um
inside our note service we have two
really important functions which at the
moment are at the bottom of this
class which are called open and close
respectively
and what we need to make sure is that
upon going to notes view that
our database is actually open so we
cannot continue to read stuff from
various parts of our database if the
database handle hasn't actually be
created so
let's then go to our uh notes view
and
in here as you can see this is the
reason we made this and notes view a
stateful widget in that we need to now
hook into the two life cycle events of
our notes you and to open our database
upon the creation of this node 2 and
then close the database upon it being
disposed so
as the caption indicates let's go and
overwrite the init state function in
here okay and what we're going to do in
here we're going to say
uh now we want to
basically have a notes service in our
init state and we also need to make sure
that it is open so
so let's have a look uh let me have a
look in my notes as well
all right
so uh
we need to open the database in there so
let's go and
grab a hold of our notes service so we
don't have a note service right now but
we're going to create that so let's just
say late final notes
so this is our uh notes view uh
undefined class notes service
haven't we imported note service and we
haven't so let's just do it on import
right now so this is our notes view
grabbing hold of an instance of node
server so that it can work with it okay
so um
let's go ahead and do that then so we're
going to go and say
notes
service is equal to an instance of nodes
service like this and then we're going
to say nodeservice.open
and right now this function is a future
void
and
you may not really be able to do an
async in your init stating here but
we're just for now we're just saying
open all right so open the database
and that's all we have to do and then we
have to take care of closing the
database so let's go ahead and say
upon disposing
upon this uh notes views disposal we're
also going to close the database because
we're good citizens of the dart lab so
we're not just going to leave the
database open so node service and we're
going to say close all right and
that's that's pretty much it that's all
we have to do for now
okay great stuff let's save this and um
i'm also going to maybe bring a crcpy
here
and what i'm gonna do then is to do a
hot restart
and
let's just log out
and then i'm gonna log in with that user
again
if i can spell pick solitude
um
foo barb has horrible password i've
mentioned this before
authentication error
foo
barbaz it could be because this uh phone
doesn't have wi-fi right now so let's go
in here turn wi-fi on and then i'm gonna
go back here
android phones usually initial
initialize their wi-fi site quite fast
so now we should be able to say login
and we end up in the main ui of the
application so this open function has
gone well
and i can see that we haven't had any
exceptions thrown in the debug console
so
that was open and close
so let's have a look in here um
as you can see in the caption uh right
now we are what we're doing is that
we're like issuing different functional
functions in our for instance let's have
a look at delete user what it does is
that it says get database or throw um
and at the moment this get database or
throw only thing it does is just make
sure that this db is available in there
but it doesn't make sure that that
database is open as such it just makes
sure that there is a database
instance in the the internet in the node
service
so what we need to make sure now is that
every function that works with our
database first ensures that the database
not only is instance is there but that
the database also
open
all right because if you look at the
excuse me um here we have the open
database and that basically
sets the instance to that database all
right
so what we need to do is to create a
little function that says ensure
database and what is it called ensure db
is open so
uh
i'm just going to go ahead and have a
look at my notes for ensure dbs
open and um let's have a look at
putting that maybe above open in here
okay so
if you're following along with me you
just go to top of the open function and
we're just gonna say future void
ensure db is open
and that's an async function all right
so
what then we're going to do is just to
say um
let's see
we're going to put a try block in here
and let's go we see that our open
function at the moment
throws an exception that says database
already open exception so what we need
to make sure is that we cache that
exception so when our uh
our uh notes view gets hot reloaded then
it shouldn't try to open the database
over and over again and if it does then
this open function is going to throw an
exception
and um
and our ensure dbs open function is
going to catch that and it's just going
to let it go all right so all it does is
that
we just ensure that we're not opening
the database over and over again because
it's just an overhead okay
so what we're going to do then is we're
going to say awaits open in here
and in here we say we're catching
database
already open exception and we're just
going to let it go in this case so
we just say
sorry on all right so now we have this
intro db function is open uh it's your
db is open function
and we need to start using that um
so let me bring up the right caption so
we need to start using ensure dbs open
function in various functionalities in
our application so let's first go to
delete user
here
and uh we're just going to say await
ensure db is open that's the first place
and let's go to create user
um
we have a function called create user
here
and we're gonna wait on ensure db is
open
okay
that was create user now let's go to
getuser
this function get user right here
if i can go to it for some reason i'm
not able to go to it here and let's say
wait db is over
uh that that that's that part let's go
to get all notes
function get all notes and do the same
thing await
on make sure db is open
oh also i can see i didn't actually call
the function so let's make sure that
i've done it in the other places i'm
just going to copy that code and ensure
bb is open let's just make sure that i'm
actually calling the function and like
i'm not like placing it just there
so it looks fine all right
and so you have to do it in get all
nodes function as well
and we're going to go to create node and
do the same thing so let's just go and
await on
actually paste that code in there wait
ensure db is open
and we're we need to do it in um
so we not we've done it in create node
and let's go ahead to delete node delete
node
and paste the function right there as
well sorry paste the
invocation of the function
delete all nodes
as well delete all nodes right there
do the same thing and also we do it in
gets note
here
the same thing
and also we have what else do we have um
update notes
right there
and we do it as the first call
but and then uh where else do we have to
do it
let's see we've done it now delete user
yeah i think now we place the ensure dbs
open all those calls all right
okay that was a lot of information um so
what we need to do now is to
make sure basically that we work on our
notes view as we promised in the
beginning of this chapter
now you see
the reason that we created the ensure db
is open is that before any of these
functions are called that our code is
actually going to open the database for
us that means in our notes view we don't
actually have to do this anymore because
we know that by issuing any database
related commands to our nodes service
that that function in itself is going to
open the database for us it's just a
nice little feature in our node servers
to make sure that we don't have to make
an extra call to open the database
um before we
start using our node service okay so
it's just like a convenient a little
function
all right as the captioning case now i'm
going to talk about future builder and
async snapshot well um we've talked
actually previously a little bit about
future builders before
but uh what a future builder is maybe
actually you should write it here future
builder and then go to the code so you
see it a little bit better you can see
it is a stateful widget so and what it
does is that it subscribes to a future
that will return its value in the future
if you're familiar with javascript then
you'll know it as promises
um
and uh if you're familiar with rx swift
or any rx related then you'll know
probably as like a single or an
observable kind of actually not an
observable because that's a stream
builder a future builder is kind of like
a single builder meaning that a value
that starts someplace and then
calculates something returns its value
and then it finishes that's it
so a future builder allows you to submit
a future
and it will allow you to submit a
builder meaning that
it takes that chunk of code that
produces a value as a future it says
okay now it's mine i will take it
subscribe to it as the value of this
future changes i will give you the
ability to return various widgets that
need to be displayed on the screen so it
basically ties
your future logic with your ui logic so
it's
absolutely beautiful
so what we need to do now is to make
sure that upon going to our build
function right there in the body you see
in the body of our notes view here
we need to make sure that
we are
creating a user or getting the current
user from the database if it already
exists and we're creating that user if
that user doesn't exist and
if you remember we have this function
already it is called gets or creates
something something a get or a create
user and it's a future so we're going to
create a future builder in our uh notes
view that subscribes itself to the value
that is returned by this and then it
will tell us about various updates and
these various updates are going to be
provided to us as something called an
async snapshot an async snapshot is
basically as its name indicates is a
wrapper as a snapshot around an
asynchronous functionality which is in
this case our future of
get or create user
so that's what we're going to do in our
notes view
as you can see in the
caption we're going to now return a
future builder in nodesview.
and actually that should say notes view
notes underscore
view so i'm going to fix the caption as
well so
i don't confuse anybody including myself
and notes view
here
so now it's better i apologize for that
so
right now we have this hello world but
we're gonna change that so it returns a
notes view so i'm gonna say sorry a
future builder so let's say we now
return a future builder
and now it says okay there are two
parameters that we have to provide one
is the future the other one is actually
the builder function so the builder
sorry the future in itself is going to
be
you see the future is
our note service
get or create the user and the email if
you remember is the current user's email
address which we created a getter for
called user email so let's go put that
in there user email and then you can see
it's still complaining saying that the
builder function hasn't been
provided
so let's go and say then that we have a
builder function
and right there and i talked about async
snapshot because that's the parameter
that you get in here is this is async
snap snapshot of object right now
but we're gonna fix that so um
let's then in here um
let's then talk about actually
this functionality right here
so
after we get the current user or creates
a new user if that user hasn't existed
in our database we also need to grab all
the nodes for that user
and
we don't right now
have the functionality to
have like a stream of all the nodes for
the current user we're going to add that
soon but as you can see in the caching
is we can achieve this with our stream
controller which we've already placed
like the groundwork for in our node
service
so let's go and create a little
functionality in here in our notes
service dot dart
and as you can see it
allows you to retrieve all the notes so
we're just going to say stream
of a list of database notes
database notes like that
and we it's a getter and we call it all
notes okay and what it does is is in
itself is gonna subscribe to this note
stream controller and retrieve all the
notes from that controller because
remember this note stream controller in
it
in itself contains this guy all right
so and that's what we're going to do
we're going to say it returns the node
stream controller stream
actually another stream get all not so
sorry that was wrong
and stream
all right
so that's our getter for getting all the
notes um now what we need to do now that
we've created our uh so back into back
in note2.dart now that we have
created our
user
what we need to make sure of is that if
the user could be created then we are
going to work with something called a
stream builder that retrieves all the
nodes from the node service and then
renders them on the screen okay
but we can't yet render them we don't
have any user generated content and we
also don't know yet how to render them
so first let's take care of something in
here this snapshot in here what we need
to do is to say if snapchat
connection state is connection
state dot done
like this
um
if that's the case then we're gonna do
some logic in here so let's just say
return a text of hello for now okay
actually we need to maybe switch this so
let's just say switch
snapshot dots connection state and i
really like to get uh visual studio code
to complete the rest for me so i don't
like to write all the cases so i'm just
gonna say command dot or on mac or
control dot on linux and windows i say
add missing case clauses and in the case
of done i'm just going to say return
this text okay
if the creation or the retrieval of the
current user was completed then just
return this text hello
and in any other case for instance in
the case of default
we're just going to return
a circular progress indicator just like
that
okay then i'm gonna put the case of done
above that
like that all right
let's then do a hot restart and i can
see my um scrcpy kind of just crashed so
yeah stuff like that happens sometimes
and that's okay let me go ahead and go
back to this shell and say hcr cpy
the application is working fine it's
just that scr cpy crest so i'm just
gonna say your notes will appear here
now
command s
actually my debug process has crashed as
well so
i'm going to run the application now
again
hopefully this
gradle task goes fast because we've
already compiled the application from
before
so what we need to do you see we are now
taking care of making sure that the user
is created in the database if it didn't
exist or we're getting the user if that
user exists in the database but what we
also need to do is to start listening to
changes to this stream which is in our
note service called all nodes and
depending on the state of that stream
then we're going to build our user
interface all right so in this in here
we're actually not going to return like
a text of hey your notes will appear
here but we're actually going to use a
stream builder which is very similar to
a future builder but it actually listens
to changes to a stream okay
so
oops did i just kill the application
right here
so there we go your notes will appear
here so
that seems to be working fine so let's
go in here and then say that we want to
um
return
our stream builder i'm going to put this
back and before we do that i want to
explain this little thing that i've
shown in the captions
what are the waiting and dawn flags in
the connection state you see
both a stream builder and a future
builder work with something called an
async snapshot which is this guy you see
async snapshot and this async snapshot
can have various connection states so if
you go to connection state in there and
you can see we have none waiting active
done all right so
when you when you have you see in the
case of an active says for example a
stream that has returned at least one
value but is not yet done
so that's for a that's for a stream
uh but if you're waiting for a future or
a stream then you're gonna get this
waiting flag and it done is gonna happen
for your um a future so a future that
has completed its task as i said it does
something and it completes but a stream
usually it just keeps living so you
can't like hook into or you shouldn't
hook into the done event for a stream
but you should actually hook into your
waiting um
connection state so that's what we're
going to do so connections stay done for
a future and a connection state of um
are
waiting for the stream so in here let's
then create a
stream builder
and our stream
is going to be our note services all
notes um
so that's the stream itself and then we
need a builder and let's get visual
studio to complete that for us um
okay and in the builder what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say switch
snapshot connection state
like this get visual studio code to
complete the rest for you
in the case of
waiting
we're just going to say
return
paused text waiting
for all notes
okay
i'm going to remove the break from here
and in any other case so in the case of
default we're just going to say
return
on circular progress indicator just like
that
so now you see if i command s to hot
reload then it just says waiting for all
nodes to appear on the screen so
this is now like the skeleton of our
application's notes view so that it
takes care of two things it gets the
current user using his or her email
address if that user already exists in
the database or creates it so that's the
future builder and the
the widget returned by the future
builder in itself is a stream builder
so the stream builder then calculates
all the nodes and returns them from the
node service and then it has a
connection state and waiting which in
turn right now is saying waiting for all
nodes and we're going to change this
later
so that
so that uh
it doesn't just return a text it
actually returns a list of notes all
right so
now let's talk about something else
before we wrap up this chapter and you
see at the moment what we're doing is
that we're saying our note service um is
a new service right here so every time
go into init states if i command s in
here or if you did a hot reload or hot
restarting here actually hot restart
this
i can see maybe that is the reason we're
crashing the entire application because
we're creating a new node service so
that could be the reason i can see hot
restart is a little bit flaky right now
so um so that is pretty much the reason
we're going to create a single now if
you're not familiar with what a
singleton is a singleton essentially is
a pattern used in software development
where you create a
service for instance or a class instance
where that class instance is only one
inside the entire application right now
any place in our app we can go and
create a new instance of node service
but if you think about it the node
service should only exist as one copy in
the entire application it shouldn't be
like made new copies of this note
service over and over again so that's
what a singleton is and that's what
we're going to do with our note service
so i see i have a little bit of problem
with my um
captions and i'm going to bring the next
captioner and fix that
so let's go ahead first and uh
before i run the application maybe we
should fix this problem with our
singleton so let's go to our note
service
and we're going to create a single now
singleton pattern in various languages
i mean it differs from language language
and dart is not as clean to be honest
with you in my opinion as it should be
such as it is in languages such as swift
um but it is what it is and we need to
kind of live with it the way uh it works
right now
so the way that we do it uh that we make
our
class note service a singleton is to go
ahead and
first create a private
constructor for our class so we're going
to say note service
underscore and just a
shared instance
and this is just a function name it's
just a private initializer to this class
okay
and what we're going to do then is we're
going to say static
final
notes
service so we're creating a shared
instance and we're going to say notes
service
got shared instance so this creates that
shared instance for us but no one from
the outside world is going to be able to
then make a call to these two because
they are well private so now we're going
to create a factory constructor we're
going to call it note service
like that and that is going to return a
shared instance for us so it's just a
hack to be honest with you in my opinion
at least it's it's a hacky way of
creating a singleton but that's the way
it works in dart at least for now
all right now we've created our
singleton so what we can do then is i
mean we don't have to make any changes
to this guy to the init state because
right now it's making any
it's constructing node service and we
have changed that so that anyone who
calls node service like this is actually
coming to the factory constructor which
then in turns returns this shared
instance which in turn calls this
private factory and it causes private
initializer or constructor so it's like
a three layer
deep in order to create a singleton
all right well done we
i mean we could also try to run the
application while all this is going on
and i can bring up scr cpy again and if
it's doing any better bring it up here
okay
so
we've done quite a lot of work we've
laid the groundwork for the next chapter
so now we have the ability to hook into
all the notes available in our database
which is being controlled by a stream
and a stream controller and we're then
being able then we're able to display
those notes on the screen use using this
stream builder which i'm trying to find
right now which is right here okay so
we've done quite a lot of work and well
done to you for sticking with me
throughout this chapter
as is the tradition we are doing in
every other chapter by the end of
chapter we commit our work and also tag
them so let's go ahead and do that i'm
going to change the
screen layout a little bit get rid of
the cr cpy it has been a little bit
angry with us today this scr cpy
and here's the screen layout and i'm
going to increase the font size of it
and a new shell all right so in the
previous chapter we uh committed and
tagged our work as a
step 11 i believe so if you say git tag
you can see we have up to step 11. let's
go ahead and say git status first
yep some files that have been modified
and we
add all the files and then we say
step 12 this time and we push our
changes
and then we're going to tag our work as
well as step
and then we push our attacks
fantastic well done now
again uh what we do in the end of every
chapter is we talked a little bit about
what we're gonna talk about in the next
chapter
and as the caption indicates we're gonna
uh
we're done with the basics of the notes
but we have no data and that's what
we're gonna fix a remedy in the next
chapter so we're gonna talk about how we
allow the user to press a button for
instance in order to create a new note
and for that note then to appear in our
stream builder and display to the user
so
maybe you want to take a little break
some refreshments do that please and
i'll see you in the next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 30
of this flutter course in the previous
chapters we've been working quite a lot
with our database layer and we've also
been working with the ui in order to
kind of make sure that we can
have a list of notes um but as you've
seen in the previous chapters we don't
have notes or
we don't actually have
the ability for the user to create these
notes so starting from this chapter
we're going to start working on creating
some sort of user interface in which the
user can enter
their notes and those notes will be
saved then with our quad servers that
we've created in one of the previous
chapters
before we carry on let's take care of
one thing at the moment our notes view
doesn't really have like the proper
title i'm going to bring the code here
on the screen so you see it as well
and i'm going to bring scrcpy you may
have your simulator or emulator um or an
actual device on the screen so that's
also fine
let's do some rearrangement here and i'm
also going to rearrange the screen here
so you see the code better at the moment
the ui and the title of our main ui is
just saying main ui so let's take care
of that and that's inside notes view
dart
let's find where we're creating the app
bar and here we're saying main ui so as
the caption indicates we're gonna change
that to your notes
like this and command s hot reload and
then we can see your notes appear there
so that part is now done um
so
let's now have a look at how we're gonna
enable a user to create new notes in our
application you see
um
there are different ways of going about
doing that there are like some
applications that will display
something called a floating action
button a floating action button is a
button that appears usually to the
bottom right of the screen if you have
languages which are left to right or if
you have arabic lang like arabic persian
language like that that you write from
right to left then that floating action
button should appear on bottom left so
it's kind of like a button that appears
just floating on the screen
um and usually it's like out of uh out
of your um out of the way for your main
ui
uh however it can get sometimes in the
middle of the way so
um
for instance if you have a list of notes
and these notes can like their titles
can go to a few lines of text and then
you have a floating button that sits
like at the bottom of the screen it
could just block some again parts of
your content so
some people don't like floating action
buttons
and floating bar action buttons are
usually
they usually appear in android
applications is i think it's it's coming
from material design from google i could
be wrong about this but usually you
don't see them in ios applications and
since we're developing our application
to be user friendly for both ios and
android users we're not going to use
floating action buttons for now but
there's just to be clear there's really
nothing wrong with floating action
buttons so
so what we could do is either we could
go in our menu here where we have log
out and create a new item in here that
says for instance a plus or add
add a new note or something like that
i'm sorry i'll just add this also
to uh do not disturb so we could either
add an item in here that says add note
something like that or we could go to
this bar that we have up here our app
bar
and add a new item just like we have
this three vertical
dots we could add a new item in there
so now
then it comes to kind of like preference
and some sort of reasoning of why we
should add
the plus button the way we're gonna add
it and my reasoning behind um
wanting to put the plus button
but like beside this
these vertical three dots is that
adding a new note is pretty much like
one of the main tasks users would want
to do in your application's main user
interface so they either go in here to
and delete their notes update their
notes or add a new note so there are
three things they're going to do
deleting notes is usually not that
common so updating notes and adding new
notes should be like the main actions
that your users perform in your main uh
application ui so it should be very
instantaneous it should just be very
easy for users to do that so if you put
a plus button here
beside this these three vertical dots
then it takes the user just one click to
go to the new screen in order to create
a new node however if you put like add
to notes
menu in here then they have to first do
one tab to go here and then another tab
in order to create to go to the next
screen and that's just like one tab
extra
and that's where we're gonna add a plus
button beside these three vertical dots
so before we get started with that let's
go ahead and
do some preparation for that so we need
a widget and which is going to be our
new notes view and as you can see we're
going to create a new file for it inside
lib views notes which is a new folder i
believe which we haven't had from before
let's go in here we have views as you
can see and we don't have a folder
called notes so
in views what we're going to create now
is this dart file new node view so i'm
just going to right click on it and say
here i'm going to say a folder called
notes which we don't have yet
and i'm going to say new notes view dot
dart okay so that's that file already
we're not going to do anything in that
file yet
and now that we have our
notes folder under views it just makes
sense to move our notes view here as
well which is at the moment sitting
under views you can see the breadcrumb
here says lib views notes view it makes
sense now to move this notes view which
is the list of our notes into this notes
folder as well so i'm going to need you
to just drag that file and place it
inside the notes folder
okay
all right that's great
excuse me so we've done that now
um
now what you may have noticed if i bring
the
list a little bit higher now that we've
done that
also let's just make sure we haven't
broken any uh
imports
notes view oh i see that's that's really
great because by dragging the notes view
into
the notes folder visual studio was
intelligent enough to refactor also all
the imports that we're referring to
notes view so your editor of choice like
if you're using sublime or if you're
using some vim for instance it may not
be able to automatically take care of
that so by you moving your notes view
inside the notes folder depending on how
you do it you may need to fix your
imports as well so
if you search for nodesview. let's have
a look at
i can see the only place it was imported
it was the main.dart file so you will
you might need to go and fix that import
in there okay so if you're getting an
error for your imports then you know why
all right so
that's that's moving our notes you
now if you've noticed if you go back to
the editor here you'll you probably have
noticed that we have some red files in
here and it's because
we have added um
our email uh
an email field to our auth user so if
you go in here you can see that we added
this email field in our auth user in one
of the previous chapters
because we needed
to be able to retrieve
nodes for a specific auth user from our
node service okay
so after adding that now we've broken
our tests and we haven't really had the
time yet to fix the test so
uh
let's have a look at how we can fix our
test if we if you dr uh scroll down a
little bit in our tests file you will
notice where we've broken the test and
this is here we're in two places where
we're creating an off user okay here
and the way we're working with this off
user in our test is not really something
that we're writing tests for later like
we're not actually creating an off user
and then
doing a test against the off users email
so it's at the moment it's pretty much
just decoration in that we need to just
make sure that our tests compile and
that we don't have a compilation error
here so let's go and see if visual
studio code can help us with that so i'm
just going to do command dot on mac or
control dot on windows and linux and say
add required argument eval and for email
you could just say fooatbar.com so that
doesn't matter so much and a comma at
the end to get dark formatter to format
the file correctly for us
and then excuse me gonna get help from
visual studio code again and say add
record argument email and again we're
going to say um
fooatbar.com
and a commanding all right
so as you can see in the caption also we
just need to make sure that we're
running our tests and making sure that
we haven't broken anything so let's go
to our tests in here and see if i
if i can bring this up a little bit
change the screen layout so you see what
i'm doing as well uh
increase the size of the screen and i'm
going to search for flutter test and
that's the line the command that you
also have to type as the caption at the
bottom of the screen indicates as well
and let's just run our tests and see
what we get for results if we've done
everything correctly we shouldn't have
any problems with our tests at the
moment
but you may have like diverged from the
course uh for a good reason and written
more tests and you may then have to fix
those tests as well and i highly
encourage all my
watchers whoever's watching this course
to actually do as many tests as possible
experiment with widget test integration
tests and unit tests as much as you can
to learn how that works
um
all right so that's that now let's go
ahead and change the screen layout we've
taken care of our tests now and you can
see the
tests have passed and also we don't have
any more red flags inside our
auth test.dart file
all right so what we need to do now you
see
when we then add a plus button to our
main ui in order to go to
our new view which is um
i believe we created it here new note
view
we need to define a round for it we've
already done that for um
for
all our other routes so if we have a
look at our um let's see if we can find
it
constants routes
we have verified email routes we have
nodes route register route and all of
those
so i'm just going to have a look at my
notes and make sure that we define our
new route in here
excuse me
so let's go and call this new route and
we're going to call it new
note route and we're just going to say
slash
and notes slash
new note
all right so
and remember this doesn't really mean
anything except for
excuse me again
except for you to handle like your route
name so
if you had like notes with a z it would
also work as long as you're using the
same route name everywhere
so don't think that this is like bound
to any sort of a magical
file finding a mechanism in flutter it
has nothing to do with that it's just
for you to define your route name so you
could literally just say fu in here and
as long as you use this route name
everywhere everything's just gonna work
as expected
so
that's our new note route created inside
the cons
of routes dart
as the notes indicate as the caption on
the screen indicates we have to go to
main dart file in here
and we need to then go and define that
route uh here
okay so we have login route register
route notes route verify email route and
then we have to define this new route
which is called new node route okay
so let's just let's just say new node
route it takes a build context in here
we could just ignore that with an
underscore if you want to i'm not doing
that and then we're going to create a
new instance of new uh
node routes
sorry a new node view um but we don't
have that yet so let's go and define the
new node view
but for now i'm just going to say const
new node view like this and this is not
going to work
because we don't have that view set up
yet we've just created the file for it
okay
so i'm going to close some files which
we don't need and let's go into our new
note view
and as the caption indicates we're going
to create a stateful widget called new
note view so i'm going to use a flutter
sorry visual studio codes and stateful
widget template here stf
and i'm going to call it new notes view
right
and we're going to get some errors and
you know already that's because we have
an imported material dot dart so i'm
going to get help from visual studio
code command dot
on mac or control dot on linux and
windows and say import material
and all those errors are going to go
away okay
so now we have our new node view
excuse me
so let's then inside this new note view
go creates a simple scaffold so
i'm going to say we have a scaffold
and inside our scaffold we have an app
bar and we're going to say avbar
and an app bar has a title and in here
we're just going to say cons text
new note
something like this
and for the body of this scaffold we're
just gonna add a
const of text that says write your new
note here something like this okay
so this is a very simple stateful widget
at the moment i mean it's not even
stateful it and what it's doing right
now is it could pretty much be achieved
with a stateless widget but in the in
the next chapters we're going to add
more and more logic to this view so it
needs to be a stateful widget for it to
be able to work in the future as well
and for what we have planned for it okay
excuse me so now that we have this ma
new note view let's go ahead in here
back to our main dart and get help from
visual studio code to import that file
for us so i'm just gonna say import and
you'll see it will be a new import
right here on line five for me maybe
another line for you
so let's import a new node view and it
allows us to basically define a route
i'm just to say command s and just to be
sure
since actually not to be sure we are we
are 100 certain that the changes in our
main um function won't be
won't be taken
uh
into consideration when we do a hot
reload we have to do hot restart for
these changes to take effect so let's do
a hot restart here
okay and for some reason i can actually
see my scr cpy has now crashed again
it's a bit flaky that's okay i i'm not
gonna complain
uh
it's just
an open source project to be honest with
you and i can see i actually have lost
my connection from flutter as well to
the program so
let me run that code now in scrcpy on my
actual android phone
and i'm
also going to ensure that my android
phone actually has wi-fi
as well so turn wi-fi on on my phone and
i'm going to go back here to the main
interface so while this is all compiling
let's go to the next step that we have
to take care of which is actually
displaying
oops
so which is actually displaying
um this new note view all right
as a caption indicates we need to go to
the notes view and on press of the icon
button show the new notes view so
i'm going to go to my notes as well go
to notes here
and we have to add a little
button
on our
uh notes view so let's go ahead and
go there we'll have a look at how our
note2 is structured at the moment as you
can see right now we have an array of
actions which just for now it has a
pop-up menu button
excuse me and we need to add a new icon
button in there so let's go ahead and
say icon button
an icon button has to have an icon and
an on press so let's say unpressed so
remember this is going to be our plus
icon all right
so that's our on press and for the icon
we're just going to say const icon
and then we're going to say icons add
and as you can see i believe that your
studio code was able to show your icons
right in line as well so you can see
here that's how the button is going to
look like which is a plus button all
right
and a comma here to get that working so
if i do command s in here now we should
see a plus button after hot reload all
right so but that button isn't doing
anything because it's unpressed it's
empty all right
so what we need to do is just to say uh
navigator
of our context or build context and
we're just going to push a route called
new node routes that's it
all right
so that's all you have to add a comma
here just to get the code formatting
working all right
so let's let's actually test this and
see if it works so i'm going to press
the plus button in here and you can see
our new node route is being displayed on
the screen with the little text that we
added here
that says write your new node here right
and pressing the back button will then
send us back to the main ui of the
application and you may have noticed
that in the notes view i didn't say push
name and remove until and that's because
when you press the plus button in order
to create a new note you want the user
to be able to get back to the main ui of
the application whenever they need to
and that's what
is facility facilitating this back
button right here okay
all right that was great stuff and that
is pretty much all we had to do for this
chapter
so a short chapter is kind of refreshing
to be honest with you if you ask me so
that's really good um
as is tradition let's commit our work so
that we can get ready for the next
chapter i'm gonna change the screen
layout here a little bit
oops um let's go in here change the
screen layout
and let me bring up the terminal and
increase the size of the screen so i see
it better
so we're going to have a look at our git
status and i can see there's a whole new
folder in here called lib views notes
and we have two
files under there which is our notes
view and new notes view so let's just
say git at all
and have a look at our status here you
can see now everything's
mentioned there i'm going to get rid of
this make it a little bit bigger so you
see better
so what we need to do is just to commit
this first and we're going to say step
13.
i believe so at least so let's have a
look at our logs yeah step 12 was the
last chapter so we're going to say
um step 13
and i'm gonna push now our commits to
github
and then we're going to say good tag
step 13 as well
and with push tags
all right
so that's for our tagging as well so if
i say tag now we can see all the tags
that we've created so far 13 of them all
right
so that's pretty much what we had to do
and
now as again is a tradition for every
chapter of this flood of course i
usually talk about what we need to do in
the next chapter so we can get right get
ready for that chapter as well in the
next chapter now that we have our new
note view
we are going to work with adding the
logic to new note view so that we can
actually insert new notes into our
database so that we can start
manipulating
those notes so next chapter is going to
be a bit of a heavy chapter code wise
there is a lot of code so
if you want to grab some refreshments be
my guest please go ahead and do that and
i'll see you in the next chapter hello
everyone and welcome to chapter 31 of
this flutter course in the previous
chapter we did some preparation work in
order to create our new note view
and we've tagged everything everything
is ready it's just that we created our
new note view as a stateful widget which
has pretty much no logic it had a simple
scaffold with an app bar and a simple
text displayed on the screen so
in this chapter
we are going to
make sure that the user is not only able
to go to the new note view
or sorry the new note view but also he
or she is able to create an actual note
and modify its text
and then be able to go back to
the main user interface so
we have quite a lot of work to do these
chapters as i mentioned in the previous
chapter at the end of the previous
chapter this chapter is kind of quite
code heavy so
uh but i'm gonna make sure to take you
through all the code that we're gonna
write step by step so you don't miss
anything okay
um before we get started we need to fix
something in our um notes view and that
is to ensure that we're listening to
both the active state of our all nodes
stream plus the waiting and be i mean
without us having to actually without me
having to explain that
in abstract terms let me bring up the
code and have a look at what we've done
um and how we can make it better
so
let me change the screen layout
so you see the code better let's go to
our notes view in here and you can see
at
in in the actual body of our notes we
have the future builder where we get or
create a user with an email address
and which you'll soon actually see why
we're doing this and also we have this
this part which says switch connection
state waiting and then in here says
waiting for all notes the plan for us is
to in the future soon actually in the
near future to display all the notes
that the user has created in this user
interface however right now we're only
listening for the connection state
waiting
and if you look at the document
documentation for waiting it says
connected to an asynchronous computation
i'm waiting interaction however if you
look at the active it says connected to
an active asynchronous computation that
ha and that stream has returned at least
one value so
now we have if you look at our stream is
a stream of all notes so this all notes
can either be empty in the beginning or
it could contain some notes let's go
with the stream being empty
when the stream is empty meaning that
the user hasn't created any notes yet
that have been populated in a note
service then the connection state of
that stream will be waiting because dart
is now waiting for that stream to return
the first value so that's great and
we're saying okay if that's the case
then return this but as soon as the
stream contains one value or as soon as
the stream actually returns one value
then its connection state is going to be
active and what we've done is just we
waited for waiting state but as soon as
it goes to active then we're showing a
circular progress indicator and that's
not the not not the right logic so
we need to fix that so let's go to our
notes view and right after this waiting
we're also going to
say
case connection states
dot active all right so this
writing two cases right after each other
it's an implicit fall through as i like
to call it some language is called a
follow-through for instance swift
meaning that a case has no logic and is
literally falling through to the next
case so you don't have any break
statements here in here okay
so this is a follow through implicit
fall through and
meaning that in both waiting and active
states then we're showing this text and
if you command s then you're not going
to see any difference in the running of
your application it's just that we fixed
a broken logic
all right
all right now to the exciting parts and
i'm gonna bring new notes view to
here just gonna reorganize it you don't
have to do that but you need to now go
to your
new node view dart file because this is
where we're gonna work on for pretty
much the majority of this chapter now
okay
so what we're going to do in this new
note view upon coming to the screen we
are actually going to create a new note
for you okay and we're going to keep
hold of that new note and creating a new
node if you remember from our node
service if you go our
utilities we have crowd here and we have
node service and then we have a lot of
functions in here at least let's see if
we can find the create node view sorry
the create node function here you can
see it's a future so we cannot
immediately get get a result from this
create new node so the goal for our new
node view here is to use future builder
inside the body of this function
so inside the body of this function
we're going to say as soon as this
new node view state has been created
then it also needs to create a new node
in the database however remember with
flutter we have hot reload meaning that
as you're on that view and you're
editing your text and blah blah you may
change your code a little bit and then
press command s
pressing command s is just going to call
your build function again so if you then
inside your build functions um scaffold
body and you have a future builder which
in turn creates a new note that function
is gonna go gonna get called again
meaning that every time you do hot
reload while you're on that view a new
note is going to be created
and for that we as the caption indicates
we need to keep hold of a variable
called notes so that we don't recreate
it every time the build function gets
called alright so let's go ahead and do
that so
in inside the state of your
new notes view
let's go and define and say database
notes
and we're just going to say notes like
that okay
also we just make it optional because it
has no value to start with
okay and what also what we also need is
to keep hold of our note service um and
as you saw in the previous chapters we
created node server as a singleton but
also you'd be really good if you didn't
have to call this a factory uh function
for the singleton over and over again
whenever we're working with node servers
so we're gonna also keep hold of our
node service as a late final variable
here
so let's just say late final and we're
going to say this is endnote service
now first like this all right
and
um you haven't seen maybe the ui of the
application but while we're working on
variables to keep hold of we also need
to keep hold of a text editing
controller now the way the ui of this
view is going to work here is that
instead of this text in here we're going
to create a text field which will
vertically increase the size as the user
keeps typing their
information or their notes in that field
so
what we're going to do is to keep track
of the text that the user enters and
when the user is entering new text we
will automatically sync that information
with our database and in the future when
we go to firebase we're going to sync
that information with firebase
so we need a text editing controller to
keep track of the text changes all right
so
um
let me then bring this
caption in here and let's then go ahead
and do as the caption says let's say
late final and text
i think
controller these documentation sometimes
are just excessive i believe
and we call it text controller okay
all right um that was great
so what we need to do now um is to
facilitate our uh i mean we haven't
really initialized any of these but
we're going to take care of that soon so
where we haven't forgotten about that
but what we need now as i mentioned in
the beginning of this chapter when we
come to this screen we're going to
create a new note and we need to have a
function for it as the caption in the
case it's going to be called create new
note and it's an asynchronous function
and we'll see soon why
so let's go ahead and say future
at database node
because it creates a node with our
node service
and we're going to call it create new
node and it's an asynchronous function
so
in this function what we're going to do
first is just to see have we created
this note before inside this node
variable if we have created this node
before then we don't have to create it
again we just return but if we haven't
created it then we go to the node
service and say create the node
and then get that node back to us all
right
so let's go ahead and do that let's just
say final existing node
is equal to this note
and then we say um
then in here we say if existing note
is not null
then we just return it
this thing notes all right
so that's the return statement that
means we already have a note and if we
don't then we're going to create a new
note but remember when we create a new
note our um creates new note function on
the notes service if you look here
create note it requires an owner so now
all of a sudden we have to have an owner
okay
and again remember the notes view upon
going to the main ui of the application
the notes view creates a new user in the
database meaning that you've logged in
with firebase then you go to the notes
view notes you took care of creating
that user all we have to do here is just
to retrieve that user so we can actually
count with that user already existing
inside the database all right
so let's just then say final current
user
is equal to um
our auth service
firebase and then we're gonna say
current user
and we're just gonna
explicitly um unwrap it meaning that
we're expecting a user to be there if
you've ended up somehow in this new note
view you may be thinking but why that's
unsafe well
it is unsafe it is it is going to crash
the application if the current user
doesn't exist however
you should never end up in this
new node view if you don't have a
current user so ending up on this screen
and not having a current user is worth
the crash because you want your
application to crash if you're if what
you expect from your applications user
interface and logic has not been met by
the previous screen so you're now
creating an expectation and crashing the
application at this point is actually a
good thing in my eyes because if the
current user doesn't exist you should
never end up in this view if you've
ended up in this view and you have no
current user something is seriously
wrong so it's completely safe i would
say to explicitly unwrap the current
user in here okay
and we're gonna
extract the email from the current user
so we're going to say current user.email
and we're going to unwrap that as well
because remember email was an optional
field but again since we know that
our authentication right now is going to
take care of the email
because all our users register with an
email addresses and the password then we
can be sure that the email address
exists all right
so let's go ahead and get that owner
from the database so we're going to say
the owner is equal to our
off our notes service
so we're gonna say await notes service
and then we're gonna get the user
with that email
and then we're gonna just return our
note service create node so we're going
to create a new node in here okay
so let's say note service creates notes
with that owner and
you see this
returns um
a future of database note which is
pretty much what we need to return in
here so let's just return a wait on that
all right
all right fantastic that was for the
creation of the new notes and in here
you can see that we're not setting this
um
new notes that we just created
to this note
variable in there
we're going to actually take care of
that a little bit
later so you don't have to worry about
that
all right that's for the creation of our
notes
now what we need to do is
when this view is disposed of meaning
that for instance the user presses the
back button on this view
we need to ensure that the current node
in the database gets deleted if
there is no text entered for for that
node so
the reason for that is let's say that
the user is on the main interface uh of
the application right here the user then
presses the plus button and then says
hmm i actually didn't want to do that so
they press the back button
if we allow the user to do that and
press press the plus button we create a
new empty node and go back then the view
may just be full of empty nodes so it
will just be like empty cells that the
user is not even able to see because
later as we'll see in the next chapters
we're going to populate this list with
the actual contents of your notes
because our notes don't have titles so
the actual text we're going to display
is the note itself in here inside
various various cells
so what we're going to do is saying that
if you go and create a new node and you
don't enter any text meaning that the
text is empty work upon you going out of
this screen
out of the new note screen we're going
to delete that note if it's empty okay
so it just makes sense
so let's go ahead and create and find
that function
so i'm going to
bring that
here and let's just say void delete note
if text is empty all right
and then
we go in here now we have to have a look
at our notes
and and let's just say we get we get the
note so we say in here final note
note that should be populated inside of
our state and then we say if the
text controller's
text is empty
it's empty and the node is not null
then we go to our node service here
and then we ask it to delete the nodes
right there okay and then we say use
notes id like that
alright so
yeah that should that should be good to
go so that's the deletion of the note
from the database if the text inside our
text editing controller is empty
all right so that was for deleting the
note if it's empty how about actually
saving the notes if it's
if there actually is text in it
and what we're gonna do in our as you'll
see soon inside this view where the user
can edit their notes or add new text to
the notes we're not going to have any
type of save button in modern mobile
applications if you're not a software
development from before you may not
notice but if you're a designer you
probably already noticed that in most
note-taking applications on mobile
devices at least there is no save button
all your contents will automatically be
saved so that's actually a good design
decision usually in most places you
don't need a save button usually in
mobile applications sorry especially in
mobile applications
so we're not going to have a save button
so we in order to facilitate not having
a save button we have to have a
functionality that automatically saves
the current
the current node for instance if the
user then goes out of this view so it
will automatically be saved okay
so let's go ahead and create a function
in here as the as the name indicates
and it's called save node if text not
empty
and i'm gonna bring the uh function
signature from my node so i don't have
to type it manually so you will need to
unfortunately type this manually
unfortunately unfortunately i don't know
but you will need to type in manually
save notes if text not empty
and what we're going to do in here is
very similar to our the code that we
wrote for delete node if text empty so
first we're going to get the node
is node and then we get the text
in our text controllers text
and then in here
um
we're gonna say
um if the note is not null if note is
not normal
and
um our text is not empty then we're
gonna await
our note service
update notes
functionality here
and that's exactly what we're doing here
so it's very simple we're just saying
that if there is text which is is not
empty and we have a note then just
update that note in the database so very
very simple
all right two very important functions
now we have to put these functions in
use as you can see we're getting a
warning in here from the analyzer saying
that these are two private functions
which are not referenced and that's for
a good reason because we're going to
reference them inside the disposal of
our new node view state
when this new note view basically is
being killed by the system for instance
when the user presses the back button
okay
so let's go into the dispose function
and we have to take care of uh
three things in here
so
let's go and
say that we have
a dispose function in here and that's
going to be overwritten by default sorry
i'll bring it up here and i'll write it
from the beginning so you see this pose
okay and it does overwriting for us and
what we're going to do is first going to
say delete the notes if text is empty
then what we're going to do is we're
going to say otherwise save the notes if
text is not empty
and then we're going to get rid of the
text controllers and call the dispose on
it so as a good citizen of the dart land
when you create a new text editing
controller which we're soon going to do
we also need to make sure that we
dispose of it upon this pose all right
so um
so that was a lot of code and i'm gonna
also have a look here
i can see i haven't actually provided
any
captions for us taking care of the init
so um let's take care of
so i basically what i'm doing right now
because i just noticed that i haven't
provided a caption for the init function
well we're gonna do it right now um
because that's a very very important uh
basically function that we need to
program
so uh i apologize for that as well i'm
gonna bring it here and then show you
the caption so you see what i'm doing
so we have this pose but we don't have
init state yet and i'm going to put init
state in here so
uh let's see or do we have any state
already
i don't see that so
and i can see that the visual studio
code isn't really helping me with that
so i'm just going to say overwrite void
init state
like that
and then we have to call super in its
states okay so you may have to type that
by hand as well individual studio code
was being a little bit angry at me
maybe because i just forgot to write the
caption for internet state
and then in here what we need to do is
just to ensure that we're creating both
an instance of node service and also our
text editing controller okay so i'm just
going to say node service
and that is equal to node service and
that's just a singleton so it's not
going to create really a new instance if
it already existed from before
and our text controller is going to be a
new instance of text editing
editing controller just like that
all right
so i'm going to save this and then i'm
going to do a hot restart um and
scrcpy is a little bit angry these days
with me when i do hot restart and i
don't really know why
but i have learned to live with it so
i'm just going to say scr cpy
and then i'm going to run the
application without debugging and
bringing it bring it right there
okay
while that is doing its job we need to
take care of
some
other functionality
you see um
when the user is entering text in the
main ui of the application so when he or
she is entering the text typing on a
keyboard we need to make sure that we're
constantly updating
our notes in the database
so
we're not gonna leave the updating uh
for instance while
when the user presses the back button so
we're constantly gonna do that as the
user is typing
um in the on the screen so
for that we need some listeners so as
the caption indicate as a caption at the
bottom of the screen in any case we need
a text controller
listener
and
all this text controller listener is
going to do is it's going to be a body
of function it's going to be a function
that takes the current node if it exists
then it's going to take the current text
editing controllers text and update that
notes in the database all right so
let's go and create that function so
void and we're going to say text
controller listener
and remember this function
is not yet being called it's it's for us
then to hook to the text editing
controller as a listener so we are soon
gonna write another function that
says hey text editing controller
whenever your text changes call this
function all right so don't worry about
that it's not being called yet
so in here we're basically going to get
the note um i'm going to get rid of this
as well i'm going to say final
um
notes is this note and then we're going
to say if note is null
meaning that we don't have the note then
we just return we can't work with null
nodes
and then we're going to say get the text
which is from our text controller
like that and then we're just going to
await on our note service updates notes
with that text and then comma at the end
to get the formatting working
so that's easy that's very simple
doesn't require so much
explanation perhaps it's just a simple
update note all
right perfect
so
as i mentioned now that we have this
text controller listener we also need to
have a function that is called setup
text controller listener which first
removes this listener from our text
editing controller if it has already
been added and then it adds it again all
right so let's go ahead and i'm just
going to copy that function name so i
don't have to write it again
um and then in here we go to our text
editing controller which we call text
controller and we say remove listener
and that listener at the moment for us
is called text controller listener okay
so
and then after removing it we're going
to add it
so right here
i'm going to add listener and
just add that listener back in case this
function is called multiple times all
right
so now we're going gonna get to the
juicy part of this chapter which is
because you see we've already added a
lot of coding here but no one's really
taking advantage of these so or
actually we can't say that because the
idiots sorry the disposes for instance
taking advantage of save node if not
empty and it's taking advantage of
delete note if text is empty but we're
not taking advantage of this create new
node and we're not taking advantage of
the setup text controller
listener so that's what we're going to
do in the body of our um
of our
uh widget
at the moment the body it just says
context write your new node in here but
what we're going to do is we're going to
replace that with our
future builder
what is this future builder actually
going to do remember when you press the
plus button on the main ui of the
application no one is creating a new
note for you you need to do that
yourself in this new note view as its
name indicates so let's go and replace
the body of this function of this
parameter with the future builder
remember the future builder has to have
two
variables one is the future itself and
the other one is going to be its builder
function so
for the future we need to call the
create new node which returns a future
remember it actually returns
the database note and we've already
coded this function okay
so that's the future that is going to be
called by the future builder
then we're going to write the builder
and i'm going to get help from visual
studio code to complete this and
remember in your builder you have to
return a widget
so
what we're gonna do is since this is a
future we need to look for its done
state it's not gonna be where we don't
have to look for active and waiting we
just have to look for done
or else we're going to show a progress
indicator okay so let's just say switch
snapshot state connection state
and help from visual studio code to add
these missing case clauses for me so
um
non-waiting so none of these are
important except for done
right
so we're going to leave it like that and
then in the case of uh
default so we're just going to say
default oops
return cons circular progress indicator
so for now we're saying that
when this create new node is finished so
a new node has been created in the
database we come to done but we're not
returning anything and that's the reason
you're seeing this little error here but
if the connection state is not done for
instance if it's waiting for the create
node to happen then we're going to show
a little circular progress indicator to
the user and remember this is going to
happen so fast that you're not even
going to see this however i'm completely
aware that the circular progress
indicator may not be the previous
solution but what we're going to do here
is we're not going to spend so much time
on predefining this code since it's
gonna probably be displayed to the user
on a modern hardware on a modern
telephone just for a few milliseconds so
it's probably not worth predefining this
code so much right now at least okay as
we're going on in this course but if you
have unlimited amount of time and you
and you really are attention and you
have a lot of attention to details then
you may want to fix this up a little bit
and maybe put it in some sort of center
or maybe change the color etc etc
but we're not gonna do that right now
okay
remember
our future builder at the moment is just
creating a future builder and it's and
it's understood that it is a database
note so if we go upon
the don connection state and say
snapchat
snapshot data and though it says object
well we already know that this snapshot
data is of type
database node as it was the future
itself so we're just going to say final
actually no we're going to assign that
to our nodes variable remember we have
this node variable up here
and pretty much all those functions are
relying on that node variable to be
there and that's what we're doing we're
creating a future builder that creates
the node and then we assign it to our
nodes variable okay
so we're gonna then say snapshot
data
adds
database nodes
so that's how we
get our nodes from our snapshot
right after doing this we're going to
call our setup
text controller listener because this is
it's at this point that we want to start
listening for
user text changes on our main ui
all right
and right at this point we've done what
we had to do except for actually return
and returning a text
field to the user using which he or he
can
edit the text on the ui so let's let's
go ahead and do that so remove the break
statement in here because we don't need
it anymore we're just going to say
return
add text field i believe
we're going to assign our text
our the controller parameter we're going
to assign a value of our text controller
in here so that's how a text field can
send messages to an object called a text
editing controller and say hey my text
has changed
that is our proxy to a text field in
flutter okay so that's setting up that
and what we need to also do is to allow
the user to enter multiple lines of text
in this text field because remember text
fields usually in flutter are like one
line so for instance you're writing an
email address or you're writing your
password so they're not like multi-line
text fields by default unless you make
them multi-line so that's what we're
going to do now so we're going to say
our keyboard type
you can see it's of type text input type
so then say text input type
alt-line all right so that's going to
allow you to have a little enter key at
the bottom uh right hand side of your
keyboard if you're left to right on like
english language or if you're right to
left language like arabic then that
little enter key is going to be at the
bottom left so then in here
you will get that
keyboard as you'll soon see actually and
you'll get that key on your keyboard to
go to the next line
now
in flutter as it is also in swift when
you're doing ios development there is a
weird habit of
creating text fields that are multi-line
with strange parameters and
unfortunately it has leaked to flutter
as well in that
um
you you don't have like a parameter in
text field that says multiline so
if you want to create a text field that
is multi-line and it kind of like
expands as you enter more text into it
then unfortunately you have to call and
you have to assign null to the max
line's parameter
there are some discussions on github
about why that's the case but there's a
good reason behind it okay
um
and what we're then gonna do is if we if
we do like this and i press command s
and we go here
and we press the plus button in here
okay you'll see there's a text field in
here that's great okay however it's not
so obvious the user
what what am i supposed to do what is
this line here am i gonna tap somewhere
here it's not so obvious so what we're
gonna do is to add something called a
hint to this text field if you're a
designer or a developer from before you
probably already know what a hint is but
if you don't know what a hint is a hint
is little
um as this name indicates a little text
that usually gets displayed to the user
telling telling her or him uh
what is expected
to be entered in this uh field so
let's go and add the hint and that is
through a property on our text field
called decoration
and that's uh
an input decoration
inside our input decoration we're going
to add a parameter called hint text and
here we're just going to say start
typing your notes
like this all right
so command s
and
a comma here to prefi the code a little
bit
but there we go now we have hints in
here and as i bring up as i tap on this
text field you can see i can start
typing in here and press this little
button that i was talking about for
multi-line and as i start typing more
and more then
the text field is gonna increase in size
all right
so
that is that is really what we have to
do in this chapter i hope i didn't scare
you by saying in the beginning of this
chapter that this chapter is gonna be
kind of code heavy but
i mean there were there was quite a lot
of code but hopefully you could stick
with me throughout the chapter and get
it to this point
as is the tradition in all the other
chapters we worked on
we're not gonna
lose we don't want to lose the work that
we're doing on our code so we need to
make sure that we commit and also we
tag our code
okay so let me change the screen layout
a little bit
and we've tagged the previous chapter as
step 13 so as the caption indicates here
we're going to tag and commit this code
as step 14 so
i'm going to say git status
two files change and then i'm gonna add
them all to the staging environment and
then i'm gonna commit them
as step 14
and push my changes to github
and then i'm gonna tag our code as step
14 as well and then push our tags
okay
um so
that was that for tagging um now again
as is tradition for other chapters as
well at the end of every chapter we're
going to talk about what we are going to
discuss in the chapter that follows
so we are now actually creating notes it
may not be immediately visible to you
but if you if you for instance have
created some notes then this screen
should be able to render those notes
because the new note view is doing
everything necessary to not only create
the note and let's see where it is here
create the new note
but it also is updating that note for us
so here you can see update note so those
notes are in the database it's just that
the main ui of the application which is
this node c the dark is not able to
render them all it's doing is just
saying waiting for all nodes so
it's not so exciting but just know that
you are getting there and we are getting
there it's just there are a few steps
left to handle that and uh that's
exactly what we're gonna do in the next
chapter so get some tea and coffee if
you want to and i'll see you there
hello and welcome to chapter 32 of the
slotzer course in the previous chapters
we've been talking quite a lot about our
node service and creating stream
controller in order to populate the
stream control with the nodes and we
also have a buffer locally called
underscore nodes in our node service and
so we're kind of like working with our
notes in a really good and organic way
and we also work with the new node view
dark file where we created a stateful
widget that had a text editing
controller and i also allowed the user
to enter some text
we manage even to save that text as a
new note into the database so we've done
quite a lot however what wasn't so much
fun was that it was a little bit of an
anti-climax in that we we are able to
create notes but we're not able to
actually display them so we're
populating the database with new notes
but no one is able to show them on the
screen and that's what we're going to
take care of in this chapter
so let me bring the code that we've
written so far to the screen here
and um
i'm going to clear this get status just
to make sure everything's working fine
yeah
the visual studio code i'm going to
bring scrcpy to the right hand side
and
we have to now talk about a little
problem that we have with our nodes
service you see if you look at the code
here i'm going to increase the size so
you see better
so if you have a look at our
note service
and we have this uh shared instance that
we've created here okay so whenever
somebody says note service parenthesis
then they're actually not creating any
instance they're not creating a new
instance of node service but they're
going through this factory initializer
which in turn calls this shared
static final which in turn calls this
internal or private constructor that
means we've created a singleton so
creating a new node service over and
over again is not gonna um create a new
instance
he's just gonna get the same shared
instance and then whoever then starts
talk
reading or you see all notes in here
properly all notes is delegating its
responsibility to the node stream
controller or stream however our node
stream controller is a broadcast stream
controller and what that means is that a
stream controller that
doesn't really hold on to its current
value for new listeners so let's say you
have a stream controller that is sitting
here and you start listening to events
uh to that stream controller from one
place and then an event comes into the
stream controller and stream controller
says oh um i have one listener right
here i'm gonna delegate this information
to that's uh that listener
all looks fine however however after the
propagation of this event into the
stream controller the stream controller
is not going to hold on to this value
when a new listener comes in from
another side so
any new listener to your broadcast
stream controller is not going to be
informed of the current information
which is populated in that stream
controller so if you're familiar with
for instance uh reactive programming
with rx you may know this as a published
subject and the same is true if you're
for instance versus using rx java or rx
scotland
rx swift even if you're doing like um
combined programming with a swift ui you
will know these as like published
subjects so
a stream controller that is broadcast is
not gonna hold on in to its current uh
value for new listeners we need to we
need to remedy that and the way to do
that is just to
move the initialization of node stream
controller to our
initializer right here as we'll soon see
so i'm going to do a little bit of a
shuffling of
screen sizes in here
all right so as the caption indicates
what we need to do and we need to make
this notes stream controller
which is let's see where it is it's
right here we need to make it a late
final so grab the data type from where
it is and just say late final put the
data type in here and then remove the
equal all right so now it is our
responsibility to ensure that this node
stream controller is actually
initialized upon constructor upon
constructing a new instance of our node
service okay
so let's go ahead and do that inside
shared instance which is right here so
what we need to do now is to say node
stream controller is a stream controller
list of
database nodes and then we do the exact
same thing as we did before using
broadcast however what we're going to do
in here is to
use a property inside the broadcast
stream listener called on listen so this
unless and uh
callback is going to get called whenever
a new listener subscribes to
our note stream controller
note stream controllers stream so
upon this happening we need to ensure
that our node stream controllers stream
is populated with all the values that
we've currently read from the database
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're just going to go ahead and say
notes
stream controller sync
add notes just like that all right so
this ensures anyone who starts listening
to our
to this property all notes which in turn
uses the no stream controller if it's a
new subscriber then it's gonna the
unlisted um callback is gonna get called
and then we're gonna populate our stream
controllers a stream with those notes
that we've already read from the
database
okay
let's now move to the next note before
we can actually get on with the rest of
this chapter as the caption indicates as
we shouldn't close the db upon hot
reload after opening db we shouldn't
close it otherwise upon every reload it
gets closed
so the problem that i'm referring to is
in inside our notes view and it is right
here inside our dispose so upon doing
hot reload what we're doing is that
we're saying node service close which in
turn is going to actually close the
database but remember node service is
and is was and is supposed to be a
singleton where upon creation and upon
doing an open one time it should keep
its state so
we shouldn't play with closing of the
database inside any of our widgets
because that is going to interfere with
the internals and how the node service
is actually supposed to work so what
we're going to do as you can see since
this pose function in here the
overwriting overwriting of the dispose
function the only thing it was actually
doing was to close the node services
database we're just going to remove this
function for now because we have nothing
else to dispose of at the moment in our
notes view
all right um
so what we need to do is actually get to
the meat of this section which i'm so
excited about for this chapter
and that is to start working with
the list view
and what we need to do is to make sure
that we have a list that we can
we can grab the data that comes from our
stream here stream builder you can see
it reads all the notes and right now
we're just saying waiting for all nodes
so we're going to change that and
instead we're actually going to start
using something called a list view now
list view in flutter is an amazing
widget which i can actually show you
here so if you just type list view and
then command and click
control click on linux and windows you
can see it's a box scroll view extends
box scroll view which in turn is a
scroll view which in turn is a stateless
widget so
a list view has uh some function some
really great functionality uh that it
exposes using is builder we can see here
it has a builder function and i believe
it's a static function here
or it's actually constructor great okay
so it has a builder and inside your
builder you will be able to pass two
important parameters to this list view
so we're gonna say
we return a list view instead of that
little text that we had which right now
says waiting for all notes
in here we're gonna say we have two
parameters first we are gonna tell it
how many items it has to render on the
screen so we're going to say item count
all right
and for the item count we need to
actually listen for this snapshots data
so remember the stream builder at the
moment is listening for all notes
and so that means the data that comes
from snapshot
is actually going to be
your um
is going to be the all the notes that
we've read from the database so what we
need to do now is just to ensure that
upon waiting um in here so
i'm gonna actually remove this
and i'm gonna say if
snapshot has data so that's a property
on your snapshot that exposes whether
the snapshot has actually pro can
actually provide you with some data and
i'm going to put an else in here and
upon else we're also going to say return
con circular progress indicator okay
and if the
snapshot has any data then let's grab
that data so i'm just going to say final
all notes is snapshot that's data
as a list of database notes
all right
and what we could do we could just say
return const
text
got all the notes something like that
and we could actually print these notes
to the screen if you want to it's we
could say print notes
and i'm going to bring the
debug console up
then i'm going to clear the
logs and change the screen layout
so you see it better and i'm just gonna
do command s
alright and i can see at the moment it's
just saying your notes so meaning that
we don't actually have any notes so if i
go in here then
you can see all of a sudden we got a new
note populated into the database just
because i went here and i said i'm
printing some notes so
so i'm gonna say hello
okay
see as i'm changing this our snapshot is
actually getting updated with new
information and it's constantly printing
and it's the note id is the same and you
can see his text is actually changing
and if i go out then you can see well
it's just at the moment says got all the
notes meaning that you have some notes
so if you're seeing a circular progress
indicator instead of like a text at the
moment that we're saying all the notes
it's probably because you were like me
and you didn't have any notes in the
database all right
okay now we have all the notes so how do
we then render these so what we need to
do in here we're going to say return
list view i'm going to change the screen
layout
let's say list view builder
and you remember i mentioned before we
need to populate this listview with two
important parameters one is the item
count and at the moment the item count
is all notes count links
and then we have our item builder get
some help from your editor to complete
this you get a a
build context as the first parameter of
type context and then you get an index
okay
now inside your item builder your job is
if you look at the
at the
signature of item builder it says it's a
function
that takes two parameters it build
context and an integer for the index and
it has to return a widget you see here
so you could return anything in here you
could just say return text item
something like that
okay
it's not gonna look so pretty though
and actually i can see maybe did we lose
our item maybe in here
it is possible that there is something
wrong with our note 2 that it's like
deleting the notes it could be so i'm
just gonna do a
hot reload here and my scr cpy may
actually die no but uh it's it worked
without a problem so we have an item so
if that's if that's what you're also
seeing maybe you could do a hot reload
because we've changed our nodes service
so it could be the problem that our uh
we just needed to do a hot reload for
this unlisten to actually get called all
right so that's what we're seeing at the
moment so i can see item in here and i'm
gonna press the plus button so and i'm
gonna say hello world in here
and i'm gonna go out and all of a sudden
you see two items appearing in here okay
but this is not so pretty because
displaying text on the screen
is not so nice and you won't have uh
you won't be able to easily add
interactions to these items because what
we want
ideally is for these items to appear on
the list and then they have like their
own sizing so they have a good height so
that they are separated a little bit
from each other and as you'll see in the
next chapter we're going to work with um
deleting these items so we want the
ability for the user to see some sort of
an icon next to each item using which he
or she can click on that icon and delete
the item so text in itself is not going
to be able to provide us with all that
functionality that we need so
what we need is a little bit more
sophisticated widget and it is called
list tile so let's do that let's just
say we return at least tile
okay and our list tile is gonna have a
um a title so that's the only thing at
the moment we're gonna provide it with
and you can see it's a widget
and for the widget of this list and for
the title of this list style we're going
to use text um
right there okay and i'm going to put
some commas in there
so for the text what we're going to say
then is
the text in itself is
we want to grab the text that is entered
in that note so you see we have all the
notes but we don't have the current note
so the current note that we're actually
reading its index is going to be
provided to us using this item builders
index so let's go and say final um notes
is all nodes at that index so that's the
current node that we're returning a list
tile for okay
its text is gonna be the note text as
you can see here
uh i can see i've written tile here but
it should be title
and in here we have to have a semicolon
all right so if i do command s in here
you can see now we have very
i mean a lot nicer and prettier versions
of those texts and you can see that
they're right here it says hello and
hello world and those are the texts that
we entered you can actually test that
and say my new my new notes is entered
here
and by pressing the back button you'll
see that your note is appearing on the
screen all right
but what we want to do here is if you
enter a lot of text in your
in your notes so if i go and say here
is a very
long text that i've entered and i don't
want it all to be displayed in one tile
and then nodes view so we have now a
node that is quite large
but this is in it in itself is going to
break a little bit our layout you see
in our notes list we don't want to
render the entire note we somehow want
to cap
the amount of information that we're
displaying to a size that is reasonable
and
since our notes don't have titles we
could infer the content of the note by
simply rendering just one line of text
and the user should be able to then say
oh that's what i've written kind of in
my notes and as you'll see in the latest
later chapters we are going to allow the
user to also click on or tap on these
existing notes in order to go and see
more information about them so
it's not the end of the world if you
don't display like the entire note to
the user and as you'll see when users
start to enter more and more information
in their notes it's actually not desired
uh desirable to
render the entire note because imagine a
note is two pages long or you're gonna
have like two very small notes and then
two pages of long of one note it's it's
not feasible so actually it is feasible
but it's not a good user interface
so i'm going to put a comma here
and i'm just going to use a property in
our text called max lines and i'm just
going to say one
and so as you'll see here
then what we're going to do is to make
sure that the user kind of understands
that there is more information in here
than what we are rendering so we want to
put like ellipses at the end of the text
that don't have enough
space to render themselves fully so
we're going to say soft wrap
and as you can see the information is
whether the text should break at soft
line breaks so make sure that it's true
and then we're going to say overflow
and we're going to say text overflow
ellipses
like that
and now you can see
it says here's a very long text blah
blah blah and then dot dot so this is a
good indication then to all users to
know that well there's more information
to be rendered but there's not enough
space for that information to be
rendered on the screen right now
all right so i think i mean we've looked
at how that all works we've actually
demoed it so we don't have to do a
separate demo for this we've been
looking at it as we've been developing
and the application and that's one of
the beauties of flutter
so
we don't have to do anything about this
demo right now
and
you will probably be surprised that this
is all we have to do right now for the
notes view there's not much more to work
on we've
written
we were able to at the moment create new
notes and we're able to display those
notes and one at a time inside this list
view builder so you'll learn how to use
the list view builder as well
and what we can do as is a tradition
we're gonna go and commit and tag our
work so
i'm gonna do some reshuffling on the
screen
so you see what i'm doing a little bit
better
and i'm gonna go to
my built-in terminal here and we're
gonna have a look at the status
can see there are two files changed so
let's do git
add all
and let's commit this as step 15 and
before committing it you can see your
git lock from before the last commit was
step 14
so and you can also look at all the tags
and we have up to tag 14.
so let's go ahead and say git commit
and we do step 15.
now i'm going to push that commit to
github or if you're using bitbucket or
any other provider that's fine too
and i'm going to tag this as step
15 right
and then we're going to push our tags
great that part is now done so we've
done what we promised to do in this
chapter
the next thing that we have to talk
about as a tradition in all the other
chapters is at the end of every chapter
we'll talk about what we're going to
talk about in the next chapter and you
can see that we are able to create notes
uh we're not able yet to update notes
we're going to get there soon but we
also need to allow the user to delete
notes so
that's exactly actually what we're gonna
take care of in the next chapter and the
next chapter is not gonna be a huge
chapter either just like this one so
it's gonna go very smooth but we're
gonna do some quite heavy refactoring on
our project as you'll soon see so
grab some refreshments if you want and
i'll see you in the next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 33
of this flutter course
in the previous chapters we've been
talking about how to create new notes
and how also to display those notes on
the screen
um and now it would make sense for any
user of our application to be able to
delete the notes that they've created
already
and we are not right now giving that
functionality to the user and that's
exactly what we're gonna work on in this
chapter
and just a heads up we're gonna work
quite a bit with refactoring so things
are gonna get a little bit uncomfortable
where the code isn't gonna compile but
we're gonna fix that soon
and right after breaking it so we're
going to work a little bit about on our
dialogues as well
you see we have a few dialogues at the
moment that appear on the screen and for
instance will we display
an error to the screen
or to the user where we for instance say
oh you couldn't log in or oh your
password was incorrect or we couldn't
register this user because it's a a weak
password entered
so that's like our error dialogues and
we also have a dialogue that we display
to the user when he or she's trying to
log out of the application so we have
two dialogues at the moment
and in this chapter what we're going to
do is we're going to consolidate how we
also display our dialogues to the user
as part of delete
functionality because you see the delete
part as well the way we're going to do
it is we're going to let me actually
bring the
scrcpy to the screen so
how we're going to do it is that we're
going to put a little delete icon next
to every item on the list and we're
going to allow the user to tap on those
icons in order to display a dialogue
now this is going to be the third
dialogue and um a colleague of mine that
i work with which i really admire his
way of working he mentions that he makes
things reusable when
he gets to the third time of doing the
same thing again so now we've written
two dialogues to this point and we also
now need a third dialogue and that's the
point that maybe we should actually
consolidate all our dialogue displaying
to one
function and then from other functions
we're just gonna reuse that okay
so that's what we're gonna do in this
chapter
so let's have a look at the code a
little bit i'm gonna um
i'm gonna bring
the screen to a little bit
um
larger display so here
so these this is our application the way
we've listed left it at the moment
so like that visual studio code and we
have a cr cpy there as well okay
so let's then have a look at our as a
caption in case we're going to have a
look at
our error dialog so let's go ahead in
our
let's see what we have constant services
crowd utilities we have and we have a
function here called show error dialog
which in turn says show dialog and then
it says alert dialogue okay
then if you have a look at how this is
constructed the only thing it's doing is
saying like hey i have um hey i have a
title then i have just one action with a
button
and also and that action doesn't return
any value and also
we i have some text to display all right
great now let's go to our notes view if
you look at our notes view at the end of
notes view we have this
logout dialog
what does this do it's the same thing it
has show dialog it has an alert dialog
inside it it has a title and some text
but it has two actions and these actions
they do different things so one action
does uh
if it sends a value of false the other
one sends the value of true so
every dialogue that appears to the
screen so let's say this one for
instance
our logout dialog that's the one we're
looking at right now
the cancel button sends a false value
and the log out button sends a true
value so
the dialogs are all very similar they
have a title they have some contents and
they have some actions that the user can
take on those dialogues and these
actions then have their own values and
that's what we're going to do in our
application right now is that we're
going to consolidate all these into one
generic function that is going to kind
of allow us to customize it to our needs
all right
so
let's have a look at how we can achieve
this so as the caption indicates here
we're first going to cut things from the
source and that's like the strategy that
i use a lot in software development so
if i'm gonna disrupt things and i'm
gonna like change the way things work
i'm not gonna be scared and i'm really
not scared of
making things break and i in my opinion
you may think differently but in my
opinion it's really good to cut things
from the source break the code and then
start fixing things one at a time
instead of trying to make sure nothing
breaks while you're refactoring the code
so that's what we're going to do here as
the caption indicates we're going to go
to short air dialog
let's see if you can find it i like to
use command p in visual studio code i'm
going to say the show error dialog in
here
and what we're going to do is just we're
going to remove all this code that is
there okay
so that's that part
and what we're also going to do is um as
the cache indicates remove the show log
out the dialog from notes view since
we're going to have a generic one so go
into your notes view in here
and
remove this show log out dialog all
right
we're gonna get errors that's okay and
you know this code that we removed also
here show error dialog is used quite a
lot so
by removing it if i like search for show
air dollar you can see we're actually
using in seven places so all of those
places are now gonna have an error
that's okay fine we're gonna fix that
soon so don't worry about that
all right so what we need to do in here
is before we fix all of that we're gonna
start basically
creating our notes list view all right
so
at the moment if you look at our notes
view what we have is
this beauty in here which is doing quite
a lot of work as you can see it's it has
a future builder inside the body of the
notes view and it has a stream builder
and a lot of code in here it would be
really great if you could separate this
code into its own place and we could
call this widget like a notes list view
and that's exactly what we're going to
do in this chapter so let's go ahead
in our views inside notes
in here
in your
views inside notes let's create a new
file and we're going to call it notes
list view dot parts okay
like that
and in in notes list view what we're
going to do is going to say the notes
list view is a stateless widget so we
create a stl which is a stateless widget
and we're going to call it notes list
view
as we've seen it before we need to
import material so i'm going to do that
right now so all those errors are going
to go away
now
what we need to do is we need to
actually pass
a a list of notes to this notes list
view so that it can render them because
you see all the logic for retrieving the
notes can stay still in the notes view
but all notes list view is interested in
is a list of notes
to display so let's go and expose that
as a parameter in our notes list view so
we're going to say final
list of database nodes
and you can see database node is not
imported right now but visual studio
code is going to be smart enough to
import that
so
if you're
actually yeah
if your editor like if you're using vim
or something on linux or even mac and
windows if you're using that you may
have to import these things manually so
um but the import statements i believe i
mean if you've gotten to this point in
the course you should be
uh
like savvy enough and you should know
all these things enough in order to be
able to solve that yourself so
um so i'm not going to repeat all that
information again just make sure that
your database note is in context in at
this point
so that's going to be our notes
and also this notes view as i mentioned
in the previous chapter but maybe it's
actually worth mentioning in this
chapter because it's very relevant what
we're going to do is
beside every note to the right hand side
as the trailing tile widget we're going
to display a little like a trashcan icon
that the user can tap on in order to
delete a um
notes
and what we're going to do then is to
make sure
that
that we can basically
call a little function to show a delete
dialog to the user so upon you pressing
the delete button we're going to display
a dialogue and the delete dialog is
going to be very similar to log out like
saying now hey hey you're
deleting this note are you sure
and
that dialog is going to have two buttons
yes or no or something like that
and upon pressing no we're just going to
dismiss the dialogue upon pressing yes
then we're going to delete that note
from the database all right
so what we need is you can see the notes
list view at the moment isn't like it
shouldn't have any connection with the
notes service it should be the notes
view that has that connection so this is
how you should also
like do your components in flutter in
that you shouldn't leak your services
everywhere so if the notes list view
could somehow delegate the deletion task
to the notes view that would be ideal so
the notes list view could display the
dialogue it could just say hey
are you sure and if the user then says
yes the notes list view could then
delegate this information back to its
parent and say hey do something with
this information okay
so let's then go and create a little
callback definition using typedef
excuse me
and we're going to call it delete note
callback okay and this is a void
function that takes a database note
oops a database nodes
i'll note like that so
we're saying we're defining a function
that we're then going to use in our
nodes list view which we call we which
we use as a callback
that will be called when the user
presses the yes on
this hypothetical dialogue that we're
assuming gonna display that user okay so
let's go in here and define that let's
just say um delete node callback and
we're just going to say on delete nodes
so this is our callback and you're now
getting some errors from a flutter
saying that these parameters aren't
defined so i'm going to use visual
studio code and to say define these
parameters for me
i'm also going to make them require
parameters like this
so that's great we have still some
errors in our application so
but we're going to continue building
until we can fix all these errors okay
all right that's fantastic so that's the
first part that we have to work on so
let's then go ahead and um take our
notes view the way it is right here and
you see we already have a list view
builder i'm just gonna go and grab this
list view
the way it is from there
and i'm i'm actually gonna cut that and
bring it into nodes list view inside the
build function alright so inside instead
of returning a container i'm just gonna
return that code that i've just pasted
that i just cut all right
it looks absolutely horrible at the
moment it's because i mean we have so
many errors
but i actually like that kind of stuff
to be honest with you some developers
get nervous when they have lots of
errors in their code and they just want
to patch them up as soon as they can
but we're gonna work just one step at a
time as we say in sweden we say
it means one step at a time
we're going to fix these errors and at
the end of this chapter everything's
going to work i promise you
so let's go in here you can see the
first error that we have is all notes
and what all notes is giving us an error
for is that it doesn't exist in this
context and that's because we have
something called notes all right so
let's go in here and say
now we're using notes
and in here we don't have all notes
either so we're just going to say notes
notes
and that
note
is going to be extracted from notes at
that index
and the exciting part now is that
we don't just use the title property of
our list tile anymore we're going to
start using something called trailing
and trailing is a as a property of list
tile that as its name indicates it's
going to allow you to
specify a widget that needs to be
displayed at the end or the trail of
every list tile
and this is where we're going to use an
icon button so
to display our little trash can okay so
let's say icon button
and in this icon button what we're going
to do then is we're going to define the
uncrest
which looks like this and it's icon then
it's going to be icon of icons delete i
believe it's called
let's have a look at how delete looks
like and you can see it's a little trash
can
fantastic and make this cons to make the
analyzer happy as well all right
so what do we do i'm pressed so what we
need to do on press is as i mentioned
before we need to take care of the
displaying of a dialogue that says
let's just call the show delete dialogue
okay so this show delete dialogue we're
going to call it and we expect it to
return a true or false
remember we haven't implemented the show
delete dialog that's okay
we can put some constraints on the
interface of this function yet but it
doesn't yet exist so let's just say that
this function show delete dialog takes a
build context and it returns true or
false to us so if the user says yes i
want to delete some item then it it
returns true
if it's if the user says no then this
dialog should return false to us okay
so let's go ahead and say final should
uh you should
delete is a weight
and when you're using a weight you need
to make your own press function async
then we're going to say await show
delete dialog we don't have that
function remember but that's okay
and when we say
should delete
okay if this is boolean then we say if
then what we're going to do is we say
and we call our on deletes notes with
the current note okay
so that is
just the implementation of this widget
notes list view
all right
but don't worry about these errors we're
gonna soon fix them so
and just save this file as well
now we need to move to the next item and
that's our own generic dialogue you can
see we're going to create a
generic dialogue dart
which is so important because pretty
much this show generic dialogue and the
variations that we're going to create on
it is going to fix all these errors that
we have in our application right now so
i'm actually happy to start working on
it i don't know about you
so as the caption indicates we're going
to create a file in lib utilities
dialogues generic dialogue dart so we
have what folders do we have in here we
have lib consonants enums services
utilities all right
but inside utilities we don't have at
the moment a
dialogues folder and remember that we
removed all the contents of this show
error dialog let's just delete the file
now we don't need that so i'm just gonna
delete it and move it to trash
so now inside utilities we have nothing
so let's go create this new file as the
caption indicates we're gonna say it's
gonna be inside a folder called dialogs
and we're going to call it generic
dialog.art
all right i'm going to get rid of the
sidebar and we now need to start
implementing our generic dialogue
this
show generic dialogue is going to be a
little bit complicated and um
and i'm saying it a little bit
complicated simply because it's going to
use generics
and the reason um
i've basically
decided to make it generic is as the
name generic indicates this
generic dialogue i mean the file also
says generic dialect so you need to kind
of know already what you're getting
yourself into
the reason it has to be generic is that
it needs to be able to produce
different sorts of values let's go to
our notes list view and you see here
we're going to say show delete dialog a
function we haven't implemented yet and
show delete dialogue all of a sudden
it's going to return true or false okay
that's one thing how about in the case
of login view so let's go to login view
how about this case show air dot log
remember show error dialog is a is also
a function we're soon gonna develop
which we have before we we killed it we
have to develop a new function called
show air dialog which in turn is gonna
use our generic dialog but in this case
it's not gonna return true or false so
we need to make sure our generic
dialogue as its name indicates is a
generic function that can based on what
you provide to it is able to return
those values to you
and what i mean by what you provide to
it every item
every option or every button that is
displayed in our generic dialog is gonna
have a value
we're gonna assume that all the buttons
that you display in any given dialog is
going to have
values of the exact same type so a
dialogue that shows a yes or no button
is going to have
two buttons each of which contains a
boolean value one true the other one
false or maybe you want to display 10
buttons and two of them have the value
of true and the other one had the others
8 have the value of false but what i
mean is that the buttons inside your
generic dialogue are going to have the
same data type all right
so we're going to call that data type t
all right so
let's go ahead and define this um show
generic dialogue so we're going to say
that this dialogue actually returns
um
a future of t
and um what we're going to say we're
going to say show generic
dialogue
and it's
it's a function signature it kind of
looks like this
all right so what does it actually mean
t optional and that's because remember
on android for instance when you display
a dialog to the user the user can
actually press the hardware down button
in order to dismiss a dialog without
actually responding to it and ios is
actually
not so much like that in is when you
display a dialogue it's a modal that the
user has to reply to unless you create
your own dialogue or if you're
doing maybe something hacky on the side
to say that oh if the user taps outside
the dialogue then it should disappear
otherwise dialogues in ios are modal and
have to be responded to however in
android it's possible that a user
dismisses a dialogue without actually
responding to it and in this case the
show generic dialogue should actually
return nil or null depending what
language you're talking about if you're
a python developer you'd say none
so
so we're going to
define this saying we have a generic
dialog that returns some sort of a
optional value all right
and the first parameter that we need is
a build context so let's just say build
context
and we need a title and content so we're
going to say required
also before we do that let's also have a
look at this thing that says build
context isn't defined and that's because
we have an important material so let's
take care of that
and we have to have curly brackets in
these places because required actually
requires that okay
so
the next parameter that we have to
implement is the title and then the
content so both are going to be text or
string
so that's the title and now i'm going to
copy paste that i'm going to say content
in here content
all right now
it's exciting part now what we need is
some sort of ability and
some sort of way for the user to be able
to specify
like a list of um
a list of buttons to display the to the
to the user now every button if we say
every button by default should have for
instance
we should we're representing every
button as a text button that every text
button needs a string to display all
right and then it will have an unpressed
so what we're telling what we're saying
is that okay we should be able to render
multiple buttons and every button should
have a text
and also we set from before every button
should also have some sort of a value
all right which is t optional so we need
a way for the user to specify a list of
buttons each of which has a title of
type string and also every one of those
buttons should optionally have a value
so that's best described with a map of
string as titles and a value of t like
this
all right
so we're going to type def that we're
going to say we have a definition of a
and we have basically a type to finish
and we're going to call the dialog
option builder
and we're going to say it has it's a
generic
okay and we're going to say that is
equal to a function
that returns that value
so
let's also see the map all right
key expected to find all right and
that's probably because i've misspelled
that am all right so now we have an
option builder so we're gonna then use
that option builder in our function so
you're you'll see soon how we're going
to use it
so i'm going to say that we have a
dialog option builder and let's just
call it options builder
okay so we have all those bits and
pieces in place now what we need to do
is inside this function actually use the
build context to display a dialogue to
the user so before we do that let's
grab all the options that the caller
wants us to display so we're going to
call it options
is options builder
we call that function and now you'll see
options is
it smart enough to understand that yeah
it's a map of string dynamic okay it
doesn't understand yet what it is
so let's go ahead and say in here in
this function we return a show dialog
of t
all right
and in here we have two parameters that
we have to pass one is the context
the other one is the actual builder
function all right
some help from your favorite editor to
complete the builder function which is
very simple it just takes to build
context all right and in your builder we
are going to return an alert dialogue
this you should already know from before
we've worked with alert dialogues and
show dialogue from before so this is
nothing revolutionary
so for the title we're going to say we
have a text which is equal to
which contains the title string
for the content we're going to say also
a text
which includes the content
all right
and then we're gonna go into our actions
and this is this is the exciting part
for me because for the actions what we
need to do you see our actions are
defined in here every key inside this
options
is the title
which is defined by string of the
actions
of our dialogue so we need to start
mapping them so we're going to say
options
keys
keys and then we map them all right and
this let's just call this
a option title
and we're not going to use a shorthand
signature in here and we're just going
to do it like this all right
so now in here in the option title we're
actually
actually gonna return a text button so
let's let's get the value first of this
key so i'm just gonna say
um final t value is equal to
options
at the option
title like that
right and now it's saying that yeah
you're not using it that's fine we're
gonna we're gonna fix that soon
and this huge error that we're seeing
here is because you see actions it
requires an iterable i believe no it's
actually a list of widget but
when you do a map on your keys it's
going to return an iterable so to fix
that we're just going to go at the end
here and say this is to list all right
all right so let's now fix the rest of
the problems i understand i mean this is
quite a lot of errors and you may be a
little bit overwhelmed by this but
that's okay we're gonna fix them one at
a time so a semi column at the end so to
get rid of that huge er at the end
and then what we're going to do in here
where we get the value we're going to
create a text button so let's just say
return a text button
every
option
and what the text button needs as we've
seen before is two parameters unpressed
and it also needs the i believe it's
tiled
and we're going to say the child is
equal to text of our
option title
right
so i mean
you may be a little bit confused by all
of this that's okay what we're doing is
very simple we have like a list of
titles to display for every button so
every button has one title and that
title is inside this map of string and
the reason it's inside a map of string
and an optional t
is simply because we don't want to have
we don't want to manage two separate
lists a list of titles and a list of
values and then we're going to match the
titles with the values and map is
already doing that for us furthermore
what a map of string with a t does is
ensures that every string or every key
in this case of type string is unique so
you can't have two buttons with the same
title and different values so
the map is perfect for this case all
right and what we're doing in here for
the actions of our alert dialog we're
saying that okay
every key inside our map is an option
title is a title of a button all right
so we're mapping that what are we
mapping it to every one of those titles
of type string is going to be mapped to
a text button
whose child is a text of the actual
title which is inside this key all right
i understand it could be confusing but
please just pause the video have a look
at the code and i'm sure you'll
understand it better after we actually
thought about it yourself
the values then are going to be
extracted of this type
and what we're going to do is we're
going to say
let's see final value
and in here if you look at value it's
going to be dynamic and what we need to
do is just to make sure that say if
value is not null
and we're going to say navigator
of
our context
it was written already then i'm going to
say pop it with that value
otherwise we're just going to pop
off
just pop all right so this that is now
you see why we're defining the value as
in as an optional because you see some
values
some buttons on our dialogs may not
actually have any values just like we
have in our
login view if we go back in here this
login view is going to have an error
dialog and this error dialog is going to
use our generic dialog but this air
dialog is just going to have an ok
button it has no value the okay is just
an ok just dismiss the dialog and that's
exactly what this is going to do so as
you'll soon see the way we'll implement
our new show error dialog is going to
use our generic dialog however it's
going to place a little um option in
there that says ok and that ok has a
null value all right
perfect a lot of talking a lot of logic
but that's fine we sometimes need to do
this okay
wow um
we've now written our generic dialogue
what we need to do is we need to start
using it and that is inside our error
dialogue that we're going to implement
now so
let's go ahead and create an error
dialog
so i'm going to bring up my notes
and
let's as the caption indicates inside
dialogs
let's see where it is inside dialogues
we're going to create a new file called
error dialog here
now inside error dialog what we need to
do is we need to use our generic dialog
so
we need to have an import in here which
we're going to get visual studio code to
help us with so
remember error dialog is going to just
show an ok button it has no value so
it the short error dialog is going to
have the signature exactly as it had
before which is a future void so let's
go ahead and do that
and we're going to call it show error
dialogue
and the only thing i mean the two things
that the shower dialog needs is a build
context and a text so we're saying build
context
and we're also going to say a string of
text
okay and let's import material to get
rid of that error
so that's that and then in here we're
actually going to return an instance of
our show
err show generic dialogue
and i believe it now should be imported
is it not imported automatically in here
it's not yet but somehow it's finding it
and i can see we have a show generic
dialogue actually inside
in here so this is not the one that
we're actually gonna use so we're gonna
use the one with uh
like this
and then we're gonna say our air
dialogue avoid so let's import our own
uh
show gener um
show generic dialogue
so was it a show general dialogue i'm
actually curious general dialogue that's
interesting so there's a function called
show general dialogue
but that's not what we've created we've
called show generic dialects so be
careful a little bit with that because i
actually tripped on that right now so
let's go back to our error dialog and
say show
generic
dialog and it's going to also import
that form you know so that's that's the
correct one okay
so put a comma at the end to get
formatting also working fine
and now add a comma in here to get the
formatting finding there as well
now
the title we're going to hard code that
we're going to say an error
occurred
like this
and the content is just going to be the
text and our options builder now is
going to be i remember an options
builder if you go back in here
to our generic dialog is a function all
right that returns that so let's go and
define an inline function in here and we
say that oops
to remove this and we say it's a
function that returns a map
and the key in here is just going to be
okay with the value of null
all right see how see how generic that
is now so we're actually defining saying
that this is a show air dial again it
just doesn't return anything it's just a
void all right
and to make it cleaner you could
actually specify here that this is a
void
all right that's that part so now we've
worked on our error dialogue um and now
what we need to do in order to make our
code a little bit less scary with so
many errors at the moment that we have
let's go and clean up some of these
errors and let's go ahead and use this
show error dialogue everywhere okay so
let's go to our views and have a look at
the login view
you can see now we have show air dialog
and and now we have our own
implementation of uh show air dialog so
let's get help from visual studio code
to import our error dialog
and all of a sudden you see all the
errors in the login view and disappeared
you can see we're in loginview.
so let's save our login view
and we have an error in here from our
previous import which was show air
dialog dart so let's remove that as well
so
your login view should now look quite
clean i'm going to close that and let's
then i'm going to save all of these
things that we have in here because we
have so many windows so many tabs open
that it's kind of scary so let's then go
inside the register view
and clean up this import so let's remove
the old import from utilities show error
dialog
and let's go and
to these errors that we're getting here
for show air dialing and get visual
studio code or your favorite editor or
id to auto import our new function
called short error dialogue which
resides inside
this utilities dialogues error dialog
okay
now you remember now
that we also broke
our
notes view
here
which at the moment uh let's see
yeah we've broken notes view simply
because we're not returning anything in
here because we
migrated or moved all the code to the
notes list view
so what we need to do now is to go and
basically work on
our
show delete dialogue okay so that's not
the one that we we need we need to work
on the notes views
log out functionality which is here show
log out dialogue you see
so we need to create a new logout dialog
as well and this this log out dialog is
going to be very similar to how we
created our um error dialog so it's
gonna be very similar
okay
so let's i'm actually gonna i don't know
if it's worth copying this code i
usually don't like copying even if it's
my own code sometimes i do but in this
case i think it's actually better that
we write it by hand okay
so let's go ahead as the caption
indicates inside dialogues folder create
a new file called log out dialog
so in here i'm going to say new file log
out dialogue drop down
and in the log out dialog so i'm going
to go to my notes as well and log out
that one all right so let's go and say
and then we need a function called show
logout dialog all right as we have it
here okay so i'm going to just copy that
name so we're going to say it's a future
of boolean
and call show logout dialog
and the only thing it needs is a build
context
okay
we're going to get an error for build
content simply because we don't have it
inside our file in here
and you see now the only error that
we're getting is saying that the body
might complete normally
which means yeah it's not returning any
value at the moment and we're going to
fix us
so what we need in here we're actually
going to return our show generic dialog
and auto import it
a comma at the end and a semicolon just
to get the formatting right
the context is there and we're in this
case we're actually going to say that
show generic dialogue is going to return
a boolean value all right
so the context is there the title we
need to specify kind of we're just going
to say log out and for the content we're
going to say are you sure you want to
log out
the optional remember it's a function
we're going to make an anonymous
function in here and returns a map
and for the option of cancel we're going
to say false and for the option of
logout we're going to say true all right
we're getting a huge error in here
saying that there is a future of boolean
you're returning a boolean optional
for a function that is supposed to
return a future of bull again remember
on some platforms you're able to dismiss
your dialogues without actually
responding to any of the options
presented in the dialogue in those
platforms you actually need to guard
yourself against that case by returning
a default value so let's go in here and
say then
so if we get this value which as you can
see is an optional bool then we say
either return that or just return false
and that's it we can put a comma at the
end as well just to get the formatting
right okay
perfect um now what we need to do is now
that we've written our show logout
dialog we have to put it to use so let's
go into our notes view
and
get help from your favorite editor to
import your new logout dialog in here so
that error goes away
okay so
we've actually worked on that so what i
want to do is
uh
edit my caption a little bit and i'm
sorry about and i'm sorry about this
because this caption wasn't completely
right so
i need to fix that
that's fine now let's now now that we've
worked on the notes list view let's go
and bring notes list view inside notes
view all right so you can see here we
have our notes view
and but we also have our notes list view
which we have to import in here
i'm going to go to my notes and just to
make sure i have everything in place
all right so in this case that we have
all notes let's go ahead and say we
return an instance of our notes list
view and this is gonna auto import it
for me
so like that and for the notes i'm going
to say here are all the notes and
upon
the user wanting to delete a note i'm
just going to get visual studio code to
complete that for me you can see here
and we get the note that the user wants
to delete all right
then in here we're going to make this
function asynchronous and just a wait on
our node service
delete this
node with this id
all right i'm going to save now if you
look at your
code in here you can see we have one
error here in our notes list view and
let's go ahead and fix that and we can
say it says show delete dialog
and we haven't yet actually written the
delete dialogue so
what we need to do is need to go and fix
that actually so it creates a delete
dialogue as well
so let's go inside our
dialogues that we have here
in here utilities dialogs
so let's go and right click on it and
create a new file called delete dialog
and delete dialog is going to be very
very similar to the log out dialog so
let's just go ahead kind of maybe we
could use the log out dialog so copy the
code from log out dialog
and bring it into your new file called
delete dialog and just paste it in there
and we're going to call this function
show
delete dialog
okay
and it's going to create a generic
dialogue in here and in here we're going
to say delete
and we're just going to say are you sure
you want to delete
this item
the option builder is going to be cancel
false and then
we're going to have an option that just
says yes true all right
so now you see how easy it is now that
we have a generic dialog just we're
reusing it everywhere okay
so then let's go back to our notes list
view and fix this function fix the
calling of this function and get help
from visual studio code to import our
delete dialogue and that error also goes
away
so now i save my project and all of a
sudden you see we have delete icons
appear to our every tile
and
we should now be ready to actually put
this into test so i'm going to tap on
the hello world item here and now you
see it says are you sure you want to
delete delete this item pressing cancel
doesn't do anything but if i press on it
and say yes then the hello world note is
deleted and our notes view is getting
notified of that information from its
stream builder because remember
notes service
as we have it here let's go to our
services here
uh crud
and node service
upon deleting a node let's have a look
at the leaks node function here you see
what it does is that if it could delete
a node it actually removes it from its
array of nodes and it notifies the
stream controller
actually no that's the delete node
oh yeah basically it removes the node
and then puts the entire array of nodes
in the node stream controller okay so
that's how the notes view is getting
notified of a deletion of an item we can
delete another one if you want and
that's it
so well done great job for sticking with
me throughout this chapter this was
probably one of like the most
challenging chapters in that we
had a lot of errors from the beginning
and we had to fix them but
one of my goals for for this course is
not for you just to learn how to write
flutter application but actually get in
the mindset of a software developer so
and every software developer they have
their own preferences i included and one
of my preferences when i'm doing
refactoring is like to cut things from
the source as i mentioned in the
beginning of this chapter so that's why
we got so many errors in the beginning
but you stuck with me and we fixed all
those errors and now we came out of this
chapter actually quite victorious
so now we have the delete functionality
what we need to do now is just to go and
we because we've done a lot of work what
we need to make sure now is to
commit and tag our work so that we don't
lose this work so um i'm gonna do some
um
reorganization on the windows here so
you see things a little bit better
i'm going to increase the size okay
and let's see now
if we look at the previous tags we've
come to tag 15 from the previous chapter
and now we need to do a tag 16 okay so
let's go and look at the status
we have quite a lot of things that we've
modified we've deleted the show error
dialogue from before we've also
excuse me we've also added a whole new
folder here on under lib utilities
dialogues
so let's do get at all and let's look at
the status
a lot of things changed okay
and what we're going to do is we're
going to commit these
and let's just say step
okay and push your changes into your
host git repo
we're also going to tag as step 16 so
and we're gonna push our tags
if you look at your tags right now you
have one two three four five six seven
blah blah blah so we have all our tags
up and including step 16. all right
so that was for committing and also
tagging our work
as it's tradition we're going to talk
about what we what we need to discuss in
the next chapter
you can see we have the ability to
create new notes and we also have the
ability to delete notes and also
something that we didn't test is this
thing that when we create a new note and
if we back out of it you see that that
note actually is deleted from the
database so that's also working so we
have the ability to delete notes and the
ability to create notes but we don't
have the ability to update notes and
that's exactly what we're going to talk
about in the next chapter so i'll see
you there
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 34
of the slaughter course in the previous
chapters we've been talking quite a bit
about how we can create
and notes and how we can delete them so
we've been working quite a bit with some
generic dialogues that we've also
developed in order to be able to handle
error dialogues and also the log out
dialogue for instance and also the
delete dialogue so
there's been quite a lot of work done on
that side but we haven't really talked
at all about how the user can tap on or
click on their existing notes in order
to be able to
update that for instance and update
that's a particular node so that's what
we're gonna take care of in um
this chapter
so
if we now start looking at the code that
we've written you you will see that
we've called
the view that actually creates a note um
the new node view
however
we're not going to go and create a whole
new view that looks exactly the same as
this new note view just so that we can
update existing notes so the goal of
this chapter is to reuse this view so
that we can just use the exact same view
but
when we when the user taps on a note in
the note list we're going to pass the
tapped note to this
existing view all right so that's what
we're gonna take care of in this chapter
let me do a little bit of a shuffling
around here so
you'll see the screen better i'm gonna
bring up visual studio code as usual
here
i have scrcpy who
is taking care of this android screen
and we can then have a look at the first
task that we have to do as you can see
in the cache it says we have to rename
the new node to your dart to create
update node view alright so let's take
care of that i'm going to close all the
tabs in here
and let's go and say command p visual
studio code or maybe an android studio
is another command that you have to
execute in order in order to bring up
the list of files i don't really know
the command in android studio but if
you're not comfortable with any of those
you can just go to this new note view
right here and we are going to rename it
so
let's just do that now so i'm just going
to call as a cache in the case create
updates note view okay
create updates notes view like that
if the updating i mean if if your editor
is intelligent enough and it has some
like um refactoring features built in
then
you don't have to do anything special
for
for this command to work but um you can
see in here for instance now we've
changed this file name to create updates
nodes view but we haven't really changed
for instance the class name so if i go
here this thing is still called new node
view all right
so let's go in there and perhaps change
that as well let me go to my notes
uh let's see create update note view
and we're going to go actually and
rename this new note view as well so
let's go ahead and do some refactoring
in here so i'm just going to say
refactor and let's see do we have any
refactoring features here um
we have rename symbol so maybe let's use
that and i'm going to call it create
update node view
right
let's see if it's successfully going to
be able to rename this for me so i can
see it renamed the class for me and it
also renamed the state class which is
exactly what i needed so if i now save
this we should have some problems
excuse me
but i can see visual studio code was
intelligent enough actually to rename
the main
dart reference to this route as well
remember
when we created this create
or what we call it actually before it
was called
um
new note view
that note view was a new note view was
actually being used inside our routes in
the main function of our of our
application inside main.dart now that
we've renamed that to create update note
view both the class name the stateful
widget and its state
then that new name should be used in
main.dart so if you're using vim or any
other
code editor like if you're using sublime
supply may not have this refactoring
feature that can actually go and rename
where you've used that symbol so you may
need to do that by hand so you may
actually get some errors in your
main.dart file
but if you get those errors don't worry
about it at least you know what the
problem is okay so you can go and fix it
yourself
all right so we've done that and now
what we need to do is i'm actually going
to press command s here and command s in
here just to make sure everything's
saved and as the caption indicates
remember we also have our routes inside
constants
so you can see our route is still called
new node route okay
so i'm gonna rename this now and i
suggest that you do the same thing too
let's just say rename and let's rename
that to as the caching indicates create
or update node route okay so create or
update snow throughout just like that
and as you can see again visual studio
code helped us quite a lot now it went
and updated this as well
you see
right
and something also happened in the notes
view as well i can see and that's
because
you see the where we actually
press the plus button in here to create
a new node that was also using the uh
previously uh
named
new node route but now it's updated to
create or update node routes so all i'm
trying to say in here you need to rename
that route so that it becomes create or
update new node route and depending on
your editor it may be smart enough to
have some refactoring features if it's
like visual studio code then you're good
to go just rename it but if it's not you
may have to do that by hand so just go
ahead and rename where you
refactor in your code where you're using
that route to use the new name okay
all right so
let's have a look at this dilemma now
you see
in our
notes view
when we create a new note we just say
navigator of context push name all right
now the goal here is when we create this
nodes list view we're going to allow the
users you see at the moment we have on
delete node but we're also going to have
a parameter called untap we're going to
develop that soon
but the dilemma here is that when you
then say on tap
we need to also go to this view into
this route that we have create or update
node route but we have to pass an
argument to that route an argument just
as it is for a parameter of a function
or an argument to a function is like
data that you pass to that
route and you say hey i'm initializing
this route but i'm passing some data to
it so then that route can then in turn
reactively sorry that ralph can then
react to that and go and read that
argument and say oh was i pass an
argument yes then i'm going to do this
was i not pass an argument then i'm
going to do something else in this case
if you pass a note to our create or
update note route then it's going to say
oh i have an existing node i'm just
going to populate myself and my contents
with that note and i'm not going to
create a new node remember
at the moment our create update note
view
we have this function set up in here
that says create a new node we're gonna
fix that soon okay but remember that
at the moment when you go into that view
by default it's creating a new node and
we're gonna change that so that we're
saying we're going to rename that and
saying like create or get note or
something like that soon you'll see um
but in that function then we're going to
say
where we passed an argument where we
pass an existing note if yes we don't
have to create a new node if no we have
to create one okay
so the way arguments work then is if you
have a look at our notes view where
we're using push name there is a
parameter in here called arguments and
as you can see at the moment it is just
an optional object meaning that well it
can be no or no
we're not we're not leveraging that at
the moment but we are going to soon so
at the call side where you're creating a
where you're creating a route and
pushing it to the to the
navigation stack you can pass your
argument using that arguments parameter
okay
and at the receiving side in this case
are let's see create or update node view
here
in here
you can read then your argument
let's see let's go to some place that
does make sense let's say in here
okay you can read that argument calling
now you don't have to type as i'm typing
i'm just demonstrating something to you
okay and we can use model uh route
and we say of
is context and then you can say settings
dot arguments then that's where you
basically get access to your arguments
through your modal route so now you know
how to pass arguments and you know also
how to receive them all right
so
let's go to the next point um
you see
we may need to somewhere also in the
future receive an argument inside our
any of our widgets
and that argument can be any type that
you specify for instance you can pass an
integer from one screen to the other or
you can pass a string or you can pass an
array or in our case you can pass a
database node so
as you could see in in this code let's
go in here
um
what's this optional yes settings
and then arguments
you see at the moment this guy is an
object so it doesn't really know what it
is
but it'd be really good if you could
create a function
somehow that allows us just to say for
instance context get object
of type t something like that so we
could just say
given a build context
we want to extract an argument of any
type from it if that argument exists
okay
and then we're going to use it in our
code in here and to and we get our build
context and then grab our notes out of
it so it's what we're going to do is
like create a generic way of extracting
arguments from our build context and
that's exactly what we're going to do
now okay
so
to do that we're going to create an
extension on build context and that
extension is going to be called guest
argument and as i've indicated in the um
as i've indicated here in the
caption at the bottom of the screen you
can see that we are going to create a
new file
under lib utilities generics and a file
call gets arguments so you can see we
have utilities at the moment here
and that utilities follow me just fold
everything in here so it's not so
scary to look at you can see utilities
at the moment has
a folder called dialogues under it but
what we want to create is a folder
called generics and then a file under
that called get arguments okay
so
uh let's go ahead and do that right now
so i'm gonna go to uh
utilities where where to go utilities
dialogues okay so i'm just gonna right
right click on utilities and say new
file and i'm gonna say generics
lyrics
and get arguments dot
dart
now in here what we need is um
to just start writing our extensions so
i'm just going to say extension
and
get argument on build context okay
now
if i typed build context visual studio
code was smart enough to import material
if you're using sublime or any other
text editor it may not be intelligent
enough to do that for you may not have
like the extension to work with dart and
flutter and
kind of so you may have to import
material yourself but remember we also
only need um
build context and modal route from
entire material uh packaging here so it
would be it would make a lot more sense
if you just say show
build context
and
modal route
right so we're not going to use more
from the material package
than those two
all right so let's go ahead and create
this function so we're saying
that we are going to optionally return a
value of type t that means any type that
you ask us to and we're going to call
this function get
argument okay
and get argument itself takes t all
right so in here what we're going to say
is going to say modal route is model
route
of our build context
or this because you see we
we are creating an extension on build
context and this identifier in here
refers to the current build context on
which the get argument function is
actually invoked so if you're not
familiar with
extensions i've talked about them before
and so it i think it was part of also
the dart introduction in the beginning
absolute beginning of this course so you
may want to go back to that in order to
understand how extensions actually work
okay so remember model route in here if
you look at it
it can be an optional in here you see so
what we need to do is to guard ourselves
against that so we just say if modal
route
is not null
and otherwise we're just going to return
null we're saying that if we can't get
the model route then we can't extract
any argument from it okay so let's get
the
let's get all the arguments from our
model route now so we're gonna say args
is model route settings
dot arguments okay and then remember
args is also now an object as it was
on the call site the call site may skip
over passing an argument to us and we in
that case we're not going to get any
arguments which means args is going to
be null in here okay
so let's just guard ourselves against
that so we say if args is not null and
args
is of this given type then we're going
to return rx okay uh oops
rx as t
so what we're saying in here is that if
we could grab any arguments from um our
modal route settings arguments and if
that argument is of the type that you
are asking this function to extract then
we're going to give it back to otherwise
we're just going to fall through to line
number 12 in here and just return and
null all right
now i'm going to save this file
okay
that was that part
now what we need is let me bring up the
caption so you see what we have to do
so let's now go to our
view which we call create actually it's
easy now now that we have a lot of files
in our project it's actually easier to
navigate if we just do command p in
visual studio code for instance to jump
to specific
files so in that file it is now called
create update node view so let's go
there
and as the caption indicates our creates
note in here let's have a look and see
if we can find that function
create new node here you see
so what we need to do is we just need to
rename that um
create new notes to
ask them captions to get create or get
existing notes so
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna say create
or get existing note
and again we just do the code smart
enough to rename where i'm actually
using that function as well you can see
in here okay
so you may otherwise if you're not using
visual code or if you're not using the
refactoring features of your favorite
editor you may have to rename that
a call site as well
so i don't think i have to mention this
again i think i've now mentioned it
three times so just so you know if
you're renaming something just make sure
that all the call sites are also updated
okay
all right so now that we've done that we
actually need to grab the existing nodes
if it is already there
okay
so um
so let's do that you can see it says in
create or get existing no gets note
argument if any all right
so let's then in here say if we if our
widgets like the widget that actually
called us created us
has passed us an argument of type
database note then we're going to get
that okay so let's just call it widget
note is
um
we need now a build context because
remember our extension was created on
build context however this function at
the moment has no build context so let's
go ahead and pass a build context in
here
okay
so let's then go into the call site and
pass the build context in here call
context which is passed to us in the
build function all right
so trusting that you've done that
we're now going to go and say context
get
and you see now we need our get argument
function in here but as i type nothing
appears here and that's because we don't
have an import so
i can see if i just type get the
argument and ask visual studio code to
see if it can solve that problem for me
it's saying that oh there is again
arguments.dart file which has a function
do you want me to import it so i'm just
going to say yes please
otherwise if you're not doing this you
may have to import your get
arguments.dart file by hand all right so
now i'm just saying get arguments and
remember get arguments function in
itself has no parameters so how do you
call this function okay how do you tell
it to extract a t
of like database node well that's very
easy you just put this
less than sign and and grade it inside
like that and then you type the type of
object that you want to extract so if we
just say data
base notes all right
and now that we did that remember get
arguments returns an optional object of
that type and in this case our database
node is then an optional database node
all right meaning that you either have a
node
so that the user has tapped on an
existing node and came here or you don't
meaning that a user tapped on the plus
button and came here okay
so then we say if the widget node
is not null meaning that we are updating
an existing node so that the user has
tapped on an existing node and ended up
on the screen
then what we're going to do we're going
to save that inside our node
private variable here
i think we set it up somewhere around
here you see
so we're going to say our node is the
widget node
okay
and in this case what we also need to do
we need to make sure that the text field
inside our on our screen
and
i can show you here so if you go here
this text field it should be
pre-populated with that existing notes
text and the way we can do that i mean
we don't have direct access to our text
field but what we do have is this text
controller which we set up in here text
controller okay so let's go and set that
text controller's text so i'm just gonna
say text controller the text is equal to
widget note
dot text
and then we're just going to return the
widget note so the notes that
we
could extract okay
otherwise uh
what we're doing in here we're saying
existing note notes so the logic
is going to stay the same the rest so if
we could extract the node from the
passing widget or the color widget then
we set that as our node set the text and
then just return the widget note
otherwise we continue exactly as we did
before okay
so let's see in here what we're also
doing existing note we're just returning
in but i can also see that upon doing a
creates note in here we're not setting
that note so what we need to do in here
let's just say final new note
okay
and and then we store that note we say
note is
new note
and then we just say return you know so
in here we're also saving our notes okay
so that's really good so we actually
working with an existing notes all right
okay
so i'm actually not sure how this has
worked before this may have been a bug
in the previous um sections in that we
didn't actually store the node in this
node private variable
so
maybe we had that bug from before i
can't be completely sure about that so
i'm just gonna press back in here but if
you had that bug as well if you were
like returning just on a weight of node
service create node and you weren't
saving that i'm not sure how these
um
these functions were actually working
because i personally
oh i can see that we were setting it in
here so we may not have to do that
anymore so let's then go ahead and i
mean this was quite smart but it wasn't
that good idea that the widget's build
function was changing like
a core part of this widget so let's
remove that now okay
how it was working so that's the reason
it was working but it shouldn't work
like that all right
okay let's move to the next section now
um
you see if we go back to
this part in here if i press the delete
button
do you remember this we developed this
in one of the previous chapters of this
course we made sure that we have a
callback and that callback was defined
let's go in our
notes list view i'm actually going to do
it like this notes list view
do you remember this callback it's
called delete note callback
it was just a function that returned
nothing and accepted the notes and this
way we could tell the notes view that
hey
the user wants to delete a note do it
delete that now
and that was being called upon the user
pressing the yes button remember it's
this
view that is actually showing the delete
dialog all right
but if you look at that
but if you look at this delete node
callback
what is it actually a call backup is a
callback of a note all right so it has
nothing really to do with delete it's
just called delete node callback all
right
can we utilize this also to
tell
somehow when the any of these notes is
tapped can we utilize the exact same
function to tell the notes list view
sorry to tell the notes view that hey
you the user tapped on a note well of
course we could do that because
it has no return value and it just
accepts a note so we have a little
problem with the naming of this right
now it's just called delete note call
back but it shouldn't be all right so
we're going to utilize that both for
delete and also for tapping
on an existing node so
let me bring up the caption let's rename
that delete node callback to just node
callback so i'm going to right click on
it i'm just going to say rename
rename symbol and let's just call it
node callback okay and now you can see
it's actually renamed it here for me as
well
and everything should be working the way
it was before so we don't have to do
anything special it's just called node
callback now all right
okay
let's move on to the next section now
which is very related so what we need to
do now is you see at the moment the
nodes list view it's not handling at all
the user tapping on any of these list
tiles and we're going to fix that so i'm
just going to go to my notes
and make sure that i have all the
information here
so what we need now is just to make sure
that the user can tap um
on those uh on the on tap all right
so sorry that the user can tap on these
list tiles and then um we're then going
to call a function just like the node
callback and tell our owner
widget that hey the user tapped on one
of these just do whatever you want so
let's go ahead and add a field here and
say on tap sorry note callback
and we'll just call it ontap
the constructor is not happy now saying
that yeah you have a final field that
you haven't initialized so let's just
add that here right after undelete and
i'm just going to make this required
parameter and a comma at the end just to
make sure that you get the formatting
right as well
we're not using on tap right now and if
you've noticed we've also broken the
notes here that's okay we'll get there
we'll fix that soon the reason we've
broken note2 is because we're not
passing on tap since it's a required
parameter okay we're gonna fix this
luckily in order to handle tabs on a
list tile we don't have to work with
gesture recognition or anything like
that but what we could do is just to say
untapped you see it's already there so
there is a function that has no
parameters
and what we need to do in here just to
call our own ontap in here and you can
see we have to pass a database node and
luckily we already have i believe a note
right here
okay so we're just gonna say untap and
note that's it
okay um so we're doing that now
now what we need to do is to go back to
our
notes view and handle that case you see
so i'm going to go back to our note 2
and and scroll to the part where we're
getting an error and we have on delete
um
but we don't have the on tap so
i'm going to go to my notes as well all
right
now in here right after on delete note
let's go and
add this untapped functionality in here
and you can see visuals helping me and
saying oh this function actually accepts
a node so if i move my mouse over it it
already tells me it's a database node
and remember that's just what the nodes
list view is giving us all right
and then here let's make this function
an asynchronous function the reason for
that is because we're going to actually
grab our
um
let me actually see if we have to make
it asynchronous i don't think it needs
to be async first let's just not make it
asynchronous i had it as asynchronous in
my notes and i thought that we have to
do that but
maybe there is a reason behind it i
don't know yet but uh let's just go
ahead and not add asynchronous at the
moment
so what we need to do in this case is
also do something very similar to what
we're doing in here navigator of blah
blah push no not that one sorry this one
navigator of context push name create or
update note route so it may actually
make sense to copy that code and let's
go to
in on tab and paste that i'm going to
put a comma here so it breaks it down
for me
and in here what we're going to do is
just to say arguments and we're going to
pass the notes there
okay
so
we're just saying that here's a note and
go to that screen and pass that argument
to it then when we go to
the um
create update note view
this function gets called create or get
existing node
which in turn
tries to grab that argument of type
database node from our context using our
get argument
generic function which then goes to the
modal route of that context and then
grabs that argument so it's like three
layers of extraction but that's that's
quite fine now at least you have a
generic function to grab your arguments
okay so i'm going to press command s
it might be good to do a hot reload
sorry hot restart
just because we've done quite a bit of
changing so i'm going to delete these
two nodes like that and then i'm gonna
press the plus button let's just in here
i'm gonna say my note
number one
i'm gonna go back and then i'm gonna
press press and i'm just gonna say my
note
number two
now i have my note number one and two in
here then i'm now gonna test that to see
that we can actually go and edit an
existing note all right so i'm gonna go
to my note number one and tap on it and
now i can see i actually went to
our notes and it says it still says new
notes
and maybe that's okay we could just
leave it like that we could update the
text maybe later that's that's fine
but at least i can see the text so i'm
now going to change actually this my new
note sorry my note 1 to my note 3 and go
back and i can see now i have my note 2
and 3. so this is a really good sign
because that means that updating an
existing note is actually working and
we're not creating a new note because
otherwise that note would have appeared
in this list so i'm going to go to this
new note 3 and then change it to
one as well so now you see it gets
updated all right
perfect we got updating working and it
was quite a breeze to be honest with you
if you ask me so
well done um
what we need now is to make sure we
don't lose our code so let's go as we
usually do at the end of every chapter
and we're gonna go commit and tag our
code okay i'm gonna change the screen
layout and i'm then going to
increase the size of the screen so you
see what i'm doing a little bit better
let's go to our terminal and if you look
at oops
if you look at
um i think it's was it command k yeah
let's look at our git log and you see
the last uh commit that we did was step
16 and also your tags the last tag was
also step 16 okay let's go and commit
now
as
maybe before that let's have a look at
status
and a bit has changed modified modified
deleted
it thinks that this file was deleted
though it really wasn't
um it was just renamed so
um
that's unfortunate that it marked it as
deleted that's okay though but a little
bit unfortunate there there are ways of
doing that so that git actually
understands that you rename the file but
i can see that visual studio code wasn't
able to actually mark that as rename and
it also it just marked it basically was
marked as deleted
but that's okay we can live with that so
let's just say git add all and let's
just say then git commit
step 17
all right
and then we just say git push so we push
all our changes and let's do a git
status to make sure we didn't leave any
files behind and we haven't
so in here we're then going to say get
tag step 17 as well and push our tags
okay
so
that part is now done we've
done our
updating of
existing notes and that's fantastic so
as is tradition for every chapter in
this course we always talk about what we
when we need to work on in the coming
chapter
so
we have a little bit of a problem in our
source code at the moment and that is
inside our node service so i'm going to
get rid of this bottom bar here and go
to node service
and you can see in our node service
we're exposing a functionality here
called gets all nodes actually i don't
think we're using this get all notes
we're just using
all notes stream
and um
let's see where that is here all notes
stream and that is just reading the
notes stream controllers stream
and
and uh
that is coming from here you can see
from our notes
and that notes is
being populated inside let's see
get all nodes remove we have here
so you see we are at the moment reading
all notes and we're just exposing them
to the outside world but wait a minute
our application has the concept of users
so
so if we if we now log out of the
application and log back in with another
user then
that new user is going to see my notes
because there is nowhere inside this
node service that we have a concept of a
user like we're not actually filtering
these things out and exposing only
relevant data to the user okay so
we need to fix that it's very serious uh
it's not a bug it's actually something
that i've intentionally left until this
point because yeah we didn't have to
handle that it was just more fun to work
with the ui of the application but we
have to be very conscious about these
little things that we haven't
implemented and that's exactly what
we're gonna do and fix in the next
chapter so
i'll see you there
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 35
of the swati course
in the previous chapter as you saw we
started talking about how we can update
an existing node in the node list and we
refactored our new node view as it was
called before to become i believe create
update node view and this node view is
now able to
do two things either create a new node
or update an existing one so we didn't
create a whole new view just to be able
to update an existing node so that went
really fine
and however
as i mentioned
at the end of the previous chapter we
have a little bit of a problem with our
node service in that right now
node service doesn't really take into
consideration which users logged into
the application and hence it cannot
return relevant nodes for that
particular user so what the node service
at the moment is doing is just fetching
all the nodes from the database and
returning it to the current user this is
going to cause an issue in that when we
log in with one user we're going to see
all the nodes in the system and when we
log out with a user and log in with a
completely new user we're again going to
see all the notes that are stored in the
note server so we have to fix that in
this chapter
before we get started with that we have
a little bit of a problem with our
updating
and this is a bug that's been inside the
application for a while since we
basically created our cloud service and
we have to fix that so let's have a look
at what this bug actually is before i
can
before we go on so i'm going to put
scrcpy in here
and i'm going to put visual studio code
in here as well
all right so i hope you can see the
screen so here right now we have um
maybe i don't have to hope for it i
could just bring the screen to be a
little bit bigger so if you look in scr
cpy right now we have two my note number
two and that is exactly the box so let's
go in here and to the first one and i'm
just gonna say my note number one
oops
and go out and everything looks fine
right now it's just because we are
updating our local cache as well so
things are looking good however if you
do a hot restart of the application
and my scr cpy just died so that's okay
i can live with that it's a free
software so as your cpy and and i can
see now i've lost actually my debug
command of scrcpy as well
so i'm gonna restart the application
but what is going to happen now is as
you'll soon see is we have a little bit
of a problem with our updates note
functionality so you can see now that i
now that i restarted the application all
of a sudden both notes were changed to
my notes number one and that's not
that's not correct that's because
there's a bug inside the application so
how it's manifest manifesting itself is
that when you update a note
locally it looks fine but if you do a
hot restart excuse me then it's gonna be
tripping like it is tripping right now
and the bug is right here i don't know
if you can notice that
excuse me
i don't know if you can notice that but
we have this call to
the update function however we are not
actually telling and this is also by the
way this is inside node services dart
inside the update node function
in here you can see we're issuing a
query to sqlite and we're saying update
the nodes table and set the text to this
text all right and that's exactly what
sqlite is doing it's going through all
the rows inside the note table and
updating their text column with the
given text
so what we missed in there is a where
argument so we're not telling sqlite
right now
which row to update so it's updating all
the rows okay
so we need to fix that as a matter of
urgency so let's go in here and say we
have now
let's see this is our update
and right after the creation of this
dictionary we're going to say a were
and we're going to say the id field of
that column that we want to update or
sorry the id field of the row or note
that we want to update is going to be
equal to something and where args
are going to be equal to our nodes id
so i need you to also write this code
the way i've written it here so now if
you say my note number one and i go in
here and i say minor number two then
it's going to do the right thing so if
you do a hot restart then you can see
that the notes are actually populated
correctly okay
i'm not going to do a hot restart just
because i know scr cpy may crash again
and i have to restart the whole process
so
i don't want to waste your time with
that
and that's why i'm not gonna do a hot
restart but this should work okay
sorry again
okay um
now back to what we were working on um
or back to what the main goal of this
chapter is so
let's have a look at how we can fix the
problem with our user server with our
node service if you go here
not being able to return relevant nodes
except it's returning all the nodes so i
believe it's inside node service right
here oh we were there already sorry
about that so we have our node service
and you can see at the moment
when we say
here notes this is happening inside uh
cache all cache notes which is you can
see it's reading all the notes from the
database using get all notes putting it
inside putting it sorry you couldn't see
that cache notes is reading all the
notes and then putting them inside the
local local variable and also populating
the stream controller with that okay
but what we need to do is need is that
we need to make sure that the current
user is saved somewhere inside this note
service so that note service knows that
okay here's the current user whenever i
return all my notes to the call site
using this all nodes functionality in
here
i need to actually filter out the notes
inside that list to make sure only
relevant notes that were created by that
current user are returned from this
stream okay
so
what we need then is to kind of keep
hold of some sort of a current user in
our um
in our service inside this uh node
service so let's go ahead and do that
let's go actually define
our um database user in here
and we say this is optional and it's
equal to user
however we always want to make sure that
that user is set before you actually
grab
a list of notes okay so this is the
expectation of this note server so the
note server says that if you want to be
able to read all the notes
the way you're doing it as clean as
you're doing it you also make sure that
you've set this current user okay
so if that if that expectation is not
met we're going to throw an exception
and we're going to call that exception
user should be set before reading all
nodes as the caption indicates we're
going to go to our crowd exceptions
which we have from before so let's find
that crowd exceptions in the given
folder is sorry yes in the given path
that i've mentioned in the bottom of the
screen lib services cross crowd
exceptions
and we're going to define a new
exception called user should be set
before reading all notes
like this
all right so please go ahead and define
that as one of the exceptions in your
application as well under crowd
exceptions
all right
so
what we need now is a way for us to be
able to filter
all the given nodes based on the current
user
so
let's have a look at our all nodes at
the moment here you see
what we need is to ensure that this all
nodes can actually filter
uh the given nodes inside this stream
and
using some sort of filter functionality
so
what we have you can see a stream here
let's say stream a stream
has a function called where
so
what it does is that as you can see it
has um it it allows you
to grab the current content of that
stream and then you can pass a test on
that so you can say if this object is
equal to this then do that and return
this value otherwise return something
else so it's kind of like a filtering
mechanism on a string on a stream's
value however our stream includes a list
remember let's go back here
in
excuse me in here you can see
we return a stream of a list of database
nodes
so what we want is a where clause that's
two layers deep
we want to be able to
filter out and change the contents of
this stream based on the current user
and we need to then filter the list
based on the current user's id and only
return the database notes that are
relevant for that user so
this is a bit of a special case
so for that we need to create our own
function
which is a
manual like filter function on our
on our stream okay so let's go ahead and
do that so what we need to do in here
and is to create a new file as you can
see under lib extensions list filter so
i'm going to go ahead and do that let's
see if we already have some extensions
so i can see under lib right now we have
constants enum services utilities views
but we don't have any extensions so the
best way then to do that to create that
filter the dart file is just right click
on live and say new file
and then i'm going to say extensions
list
filter.
okay
so then what we're going to do in here
is to create an extension on our
on our stream
so let's go ahead and just say extension
filter
on stream of t
so
the reason i'm doing it like this is
that so we can grab hold of the contents
of that stream inside our extension okay
so
like if you did something like this
that would still work but in here what
we're saying is that we're extending any
stream that has a value of t
and in our filter function then we can
access that t as you'll soon see okay so
then we're going to say
stream
of a list of that object
and we're going to call our function
filter
and in our filter function we want to
grab another function that does a
testing of the items so let's then say
bool
um
function that grabs an item of that type
so you can see now we're basically
broken down the requirements of our
filtering
that is what's supposed to be two levels
deep is now one level leap because our
filter function passes t
which is our database node to this where
function okay
so this doesn't exist at the moment but
we're creating that okay
so in here what we're going to say then
is
what we are going to do is we need to
map our um
stream
and that will you can see it gives us
the values so in here we get the items
and in here then we say items where
we pass that word clause in here
and we say to list like this
so
and i can see in here actually we have a
filter of t but our stream needs to have
a list of t so then that's gonna fix the
problem for us so in this case we're
actually drilling down two levels deep
inside the list okay
so this is the function that we just
created so it allows us to filter a
stream of lists of something and then
our where clause is going to get that
something and should that something pass
the test then it will be included in the
final list so
look i know this is complicated stuff
but please pause the video think a
little bit about it we have a stream
containing a list of things
now we want to stream of the list of the
same thing as long as those things
any individual thing passes a specific
test
which is specified using this work loss
okay
this is difficult i know it may be some
it may be like so difficult for some
users that you'll be like i don't get
any of this i don't understand but
you will just need to practice you need
to just grab a hold of this code go go
ahead and implement this on some other
functionalities like a list of list of
things and see okay if i have a list of
lists of things how do i filter out that
thing inside and it will finally click
okay
i know it's it's a bit complicated so
we've done that now
what we need now um
is to set the current user in the node
service
as you can see right now we have get or
create user functionality in our node
service
so let's go back to our node service and
find that function get or create user
and at the moment it just takes an email
as the caption indicates we need a
parameter inside this function that also
says set as current user so when you get
or create a user
which we're at the moment doing i
believe in our notes view so let's go in
here
notes notes view in here
uh you see get or create a user so this
is like the bare bone this is the actual
very important part of our application
where a user either is retrieved from
the database the way he or she was or
it's created and it just makes sense to
make that user the current user at this
point okay so let's go in our node
service
and let's change that functionality so
i'm going to bring up my notes as well
and let's add a parameter called set as
current user right here going to put a
comma there
and let's just say um that this
parameter is a boolean set as current
user and we're going to set it to true
by default all right so i need to do the
same thing please
so after doing that when we retrieve the
user we're going to look at this
parameter we're going to say if set as
current user set
as current user then we're going to set
our own user to this user that we just
retrieved from the database
and also don't forget when you create
this user
and you also have to set the current
user if that boolean flag is true so
let's just say
set as current user here as well then
we're going to say user is created user
so what we did here is we just said
if we could retrieve that user from the
database we and this boolean parameter
is true then we set our own user to this
user
otherwise if we had to create that user
and this parameter is true then we do
the same thing we set this current user
to the created user and if you're
getting some errors in here saying that
this underscore user cannot be found
it's probably because you missed adding
this
a database user to your node service
which is something i mentioned just
before we moved on to creating that
filter function okay or sorry before we
created this exception
all right that part is now done as well
um
now what we need to do is to do the
actual
filtering and and that is something that
we need to do is uh you can see as a
cache index change all nodes stream to
filter for the current user
and that's something we need to do in
the all nodes
function or sorry the getter
so right here
what we're going to say is i'm actually
i think i'm going to change them
yeah just let's leave it like this so
i'm just going to say no stream
controller
and dot
stream and right here we can use our
filter function you see now visual
studio code is like confused like oh
there is no filter function on a stream
but remember we actually added that
ourselves so i'm going to get help from
visual studio code and say command dot
on mac or control dot on linux and
windows and visual studio code and then
it's gonna understand oh there is a
filter function that you've defined on
stream do you want me to import that and
i'm gonna say yes please
so now we have the
filter remember filter then gets a note
right and if i move my mouse over it now
you can see that says oh you have a
database note however our stream
actually contains a list of database
nodes and all of a sudden our filter
gets one note at a time so this is the
beauty of creating your own extensions
so that you can drill down inside
existing objects and grab what you need
inside your application all right
so in here what we need is to create a
function then you remember this function
has to return a boolean we haven't
returned anything from here yet that's
why we're getting an error
so at the end of this function we need
to return a volume so let's just say
final current user is this user
and if this current user
is not null which is like the condition
that we actually expect then we're going
to do some code
otherwise we need to throw our exception
user
should be said before okay so this is
our expectation from the caller if
you're reading all notes from this
interface you need to make sure that the
current user was set when you call this
function so this needs to be true okay
sorry this yeah you may not have seen
the code but
you could also argue that oh wait a
minute if this is like the expectation
of this interface that the current user
should always be said before you read
all notes
then
why don't you make that the default why
don't you just do that and remove this
function and always set the user as a
default well
the reason behind that is
the current user has to be sent only
when you're working with all nodes now
this node service should be able to work
like to update existing nodes or remove
existing nodes
it in those functionalities should still
work if the current user is not set
right because those functionalities are
pure cross functions that say update a
node with this id get a user with this
id delete a node with this id etc etc
they are not dependent on a current user
however all nodes is dependent on the
current user and it just makes sense to
have this functionality in here that
says set as current user that is
defaulted to true so if you're using all
nodes then it throws an exception if the
current user is not set okay so that's
my reasoning for having this as a
parameter and not making it the default
um
behavior of this class
all right so if current user was not
null that's like the happy path so then
we say we return this note
it's not as long as its um user id
is the same as
the
current user id so we say note
a user id should be equal to current
user
dot id okay and remember we're not
returning a note we're returning a
boolean remember our filter function it
has a where statement that has to return
a boolean so we're not returning any
nodes in here we're just checking is
this node's use ready the same as that
then do this okay
so
that should now be good to go so what we
could do i know this may actually
and break things now because i have some
problems with scr cpy but you have to
excuse me for that it's it's nothing
that i have control over but since we've
changed quite a lot of code uh i'm gonna
now close all these screens at these
tabs and i'm going to do a hot reload
but this most probably is going to crash
the scr cpy
oh it didn't great thank god for that
so we have our notes now how do we put
this into test
what we need to do is to log out and log
in so i'm going to go to console
firebase
and let's go to our application which is
my notes flutter project
we have two authenticated users
these two emails at the moment so right
now i'm logged in with one of them i
don't really know which one so i'm going
to log out here
so i'm then going to log in with
pixeltab gmail.com foobarbas
log in
and i can see those email those um
notes were under pixel tab so then i'm
going to log out again and i'm going to
log in with the other user
like this
toolbarbad and i'm going to then press
the login button and i haven't yet
verified my email so i will have to do
that so let me just see if i can take
care of that right now
i'm going to then bring my email
and go to
and see if i can find this um
verification email and i can't so i'm
just gonna send send email verification
and it's gonna send a new email
verification to me
all right i got the email verification
and it looks like this
so i'm just gonna click on that and i
can see now it says your email has been
verified okay
so
let me go to restart then and now that
i've verified my email i'm going to try
to log in with a user
as
oops this is register i want to go to
login so
here
foo barbats
and then log in
and now i can see for my user i'm not
seeing any notes but just to make sure
i'm just going to create a new user and
say this no sorry create a new node i'm
going to say this node was created
for van dot
or just put my email in here like this
okay
i'm going to go back and i can see that
the note is displayed here
then what i'm going to do is just to
log out of this user
and log in with the other user
just to make sure that that
oh that was created by the other user is
not displayed to this user okay
and now we can log in and i can only see
notes that were for this user so
congratulations that was a lot of work
that we did and that we did and uh the
application seems to be working the way
we've designed it so
that's great job
what we need to do now is just ensure
that we we won't lose our code as is a
tradition and so we need to commit our
code and also tag our code okay
so i'm gonna do some uh
shuffling around here on the screens and
i'm gonna increase the size of visual
studio code so you see it better
let's do git status and see what the
status is we've modified two files and
we've also added a whole new folder so
i'm just gonna say git add all
and if you look at our logs the previous
step was step 17
now we have to commit our work and tag
it as step 18 and if you look at our are
your tags as well you should have step
17 here
let's say git commit and i'm going to
say step 18.
here i'm gonna push these changes to
remotes which in my case is github you
may be using bitbucket or some other
remote
and less than tag as step 18 as well
here and put your tags
alright so that part is done now we have
tagged and committed or code so if you
say git status you should have nothing
handling here to be committed all right
wow fantastic so
again as tradition is we always talk
about what we need to mention in the
next chapter what we're going to go
through in the next chapter at the end
of every chapter so
up until this point we've been using our
notes crot service and
that's been working really good
everything's been saved on the on the
device
however if you really think about it
you've now learned how to work with
crowd and that was my that was like one
of my intentions at the beginning of
this course i wanted to teach you about
crud because it's one of the absolute
most important things that any back-end
developer or
front-end developer such as flutter
developer has to know about
so i hope that you've learned that now
however we have a big problem here and
that is all our notes are saved locally
in a sql like database and
should anything go wrong for instance if
if the users something happens to the
user's telephone all that data is going
to disappear
so the user's notes may disappear and
you may think well
what's so wrong about that well if
you're like me
i use my notes like my the default notes
application in macintosh and also on
linux quite a lot so i store very very
important information sometimes in my
notes and you'd be surprised that the
outline for this course i actually
managed it all i managed all of that
inside the notes application on my
macintosh so i wrote the entire outline
took many many hours and i would have
been devastated
if those notes disappeared for some
reason or if my kids got a hold of my
telephone and just removed the notes and
there was no reason and then there was
no way for me to grab those notes back
again so
what we need to do now is just ensure
that we can store these nodes in some
sort of a
back end so that it's sitting in the
cloud so we don't have to manage them
locally and that's what we're going to
use firebase for and we're going to
start talking more and more about
firebase storage from
the beginning of next chapter so i hope
you enjoyed this chapter and grab your
refreshments coffee or tea or whatever
you want some chocolates and i'll see
you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 36 of this
flutter course in previous chapters
we've been working with our quad service
quite a lot and also we've been working
with firebase authentication
so far we've stored the user generated
notes inside the crotch store which
we're backing with a sqlite database and
we've
also made that cloud service kind of um
aware of the currently logged in user so
when
a user logs in he or she can only see
their own notes and when that user logs
out and another user logs and then
the previously created notes in the
database aren't exposed to the new user
so we've taken care of all those but we
still have our notes only stored in a
local storage
and from this chapter on we're going to
be working with actually moving away
from storing the user data in a local
database
and instead going towards storing that
inside firebase
now
when i was designing this course i was
thinking about how i can introduce more
and more concepts to to become a better
software developer and a flutter
developer and one of those absolutely
crucial things was crud create read
update and delete and um though firebase
is a good way of doing that but firebase
removes quite a lot of the logic that
you otherwise need to understand
to become a better developer so firebase
has abstracted away the concept of crowd
quite a lot and that you work with data
in the cloud and you don't really know
how that is being populated and where
that is being populated so
when i started designing the course i
thought maybe okay we could have a look
at storing data locally first to get a
good grip of crud
and then after that we now we understand
how crop works and how those operations
are performed at a low level on a
database level then we can move away
from it and go to a more abstract layer
so this was a choice that i met early on
when designing this course and it is
definitely not like wasted time you now
know how to work with sql light in your
applications and you will probably be
using sqlite more and more as you go on
in your flutter development um
career so
i am i hope that you understand that we
are
we still have good use of uh sqlite and
we've understood that but now it's time
that we move away from our local storage
and move to using um firebase instead
so i want to bring up the caption for
the next section of this chapter and
that's uh that we're going to talk about
cloud firestore so if i bring up my
notes and go to that url that i provided
right right there for you
and bring it up here
and you can see here in in here it says
firestore is a flexible scalable a nosql
cloud database to store and sync data
um
the way the way it works i mean you can
go actually to this link that i've
provided for you here and it tells you
about how you can actually add cloud
firestore to your application but i
believe we've already done that so if i
bring our um
application also to the screen
increase the size and we go to our pop
special
and we'll look at our dependencies we're
at the moment using firebase core
firebase auth and um in here also tells
you you have to use cloud firestore so
let's go in here and we can see we've
already dragged in cloud firestore from
one of the absolute absolute earliest
chapters in
this course we've already
added this dependency to our application
so you don't have to do this but if you
don't have cloud firestore added to your
application you may need to do that now
by following the instructions in this
link and if you've if you don't have it
it's probably because you've missed one
of the early chapters in this um
course
so
we're going to be using the cloud
firestore in order to store user
generated data and in this case our
nodes
now
you may be familiar with sql and nosql
but what
i mean what
i can explain cloud fire stories is that
you will have um
two concepts that you need to understand
um which are called um collections and
the other ones are documents so
whereas in traditional sql storage you
will have hard dependencies and every uh
table for instance when we design our
sqlite database we actually have to
design our tables with specific
layouts inside the table
so we have different fields we have
foreign keys etc so that's like a
typical sql relation relational database
but when you go to node sql for instance
firestore then things are more document
based so for those of you who are doing
backend development you already know
about that for instance so
um
if you're using sequel light then things
aren't document based as you would think
um
but when we go to firestore then you
will have like a lot more looser data
definition for your tables and for your
documents basically so one document
inside the same collection can contain
two fields and the next document can
contain three fields so
that's a lot more open
the way it is created with firestar
so for the entirety of this course from
this point on we're going to be
dependent on firestore in order to use
it to store user generated content which
are notes in our case
so let's now talk a little bit about
production versus test mode um firebase
as use firestore as you'll soon see it
has um different
ways
of allowing you as a developer to
interact with your database so
and there is a thing called a test mode
and another caller production mode and
in test mode and what it means is that
as you're developing your application
which we are for instance at the moment
then you may need to for instance open
up your database
um so that you can actually interact
with it with your from your application
without even authenticating a user for
instance so even if a user is not
authenticated you can actually issue
some commands toward firestore in order
to read data delete data
and and change data
so that's that's as you're developing
your application while you're still
working with your authentication but
remember we've already nailed down the
authentication so you cannot actually
end up in the notes view
or the notes list view which is embedded
inside notes view if you forgot about
that
you cannot end up in there if you
haven't authenticated and if you haven't
verified your email address so we know
that in our case we don't actually
really need to use the test mode of our
database with firestore we're kind of
gonna immediately switch to production
mode and what production mode is is for
instance when you develop your firestore
database as you'll soon see in this
chapter as well
um
you will be able to add some more rules
to the database
so that
unauthenticated access to the database
is going to be denied and this is the
kind of like model that we're going to
be using in the rest of the this course
and also almost at the end of this
course we're also going to add some more
rules to
our firebase uh
sorry firestore database so that we make
it even more explicit who has access to
what
just know that there is a test mode and
a production mode test mode is a bit
looser in terms of um
in terms of security but production mode
is a little bit tighter
in that case that it it just tries to
make sure that on authenticated access
to
uh for instance a document so the user
doesn't have access to are going to be
rejected
all right we've i've just noticed that i
just
mentioned a few things about rules and
you may be wondering about what these
rules actually are and what they
actually mean
so i've prepared the link here so i'm
gonna see if i can actually open it on
my computer as well so i can bring it to
the screen
here it is okay
so these are the rules that i was
talking about so you see
if you're for instance a back-end
developer like i am you will also be
very familiar with deploying your
application so if you're for instance
django developer or node.js with express
or whatever or flask developer then you
are probably used to
deploying your application to
some sort of a cloud
service and then
you will also be
responsible for specifying how users can
interact with your backend and what
rules are applied on what cases
uh firebase since it is not like this
traditional backend that you have to
deploy yourself since it is a product
that's already there and it's deployed
it needs your help in order to
understand its security rules so as you
can see this is a typical firebase
firestore configuration of a back-end
and you can see in here it says the
service is the firestore service and
match these documents at these paths and
also
only allow read and write if the user is
authenticated so if you're a django
developer you already know about like
requests you also get that you're in
django so a request user will contain
the currently logged in an authenticated
user there so that this is very similar
to that
and i'm sorry if i'm talking a little
bit about back-end development that's
just because i'm trying to like make
this connection for those of you who are
back-end developers and trying to learn
about firebase firestore
if you're not a back-end developer just
know that
these security rules are there to help
you
they're there to help you secure your
database because you see
the way we've actually generated our
application let's go to the source code
and have a look at it a little bit
and when we set up our uh firebase with
the firebase cli and firestore cli there
were some files that were generated for
us automatically and they were inside
this firebase option so
i'm going to open that for us here
and you can see some information in here
as you can see for android application
there is an api key app id messaging
sender id project id and storage bucket
if anybody gets hold of this information
as you now are going to get hold of this
information by watching this course
you will actually be able to replicate
this firebase options. in your own
application with my api key app id and
sender id and interact with the database
that i'm in control of even though you
personally don't have access to that
database
because that database is stored under my
profile
in
firebase console so
using this api key and app id you can
interact with the database and it is
only the security information it's only
the
um authentication information or the
authentication rules that i specify in
my firebase
config that will then decide who has
access to what
so don't worry also about this i'm going
to delete this firebase project actually
by the time this course is released so
i'm completely happy with this
information being public and shown to
you just so you see what i actually mean
so
just know that with various roles that
we can define on our firebase firestore
project we can specify who has access to
what and based on what rules for
instance if the user is authenticated or
if that user id is actually present in
that document's id field for instance so
something like that
okay um
now what we're gonna do is actually
start creating a um
firestore database for our project so
uh what i'm gonna do in here is i'm
going to bring up safari and i'm gonna
go to console firebase.com so i suggest
that you do the same thing
change the screen layout a little bit
here
so you see my screen better
excuse me
and then i'm gonna go to our minus
flower project so i suggest that you do
the same thing for your application all
right
so when we end up here then on the left
hand side you'll see something called
firestore database and i want you to
click there and just ensure that you've
selected the correct application in here
as well you may have quite a few just
like i do
then what we'll need to do in here and
it's just to say create database okay
and as you can see this is now the
screen that may look a little bit
scary but it's completely fine
and you can see there are two different
modes specified here as we talked about
production mode and then the other one
is test mode
in production mode the rules by
excuse me the rules by default are quite
um bad as you can see in here it says
any document inside the database is
unaccessible so or inaccessible
inaccessible
it says don't allow read or write
because the condition is just false
so and you can see it says all third
party reads and rights will be denied
but this is really not the
um
this is not how we are going to set up
our
firestore database we as i mentioned
before we are going to tighten this up
quite a lot in in the future but not
just right now so i need you go into
start in test mode and you'll get this
absolutely beautiful um
message saying in um the default
security rules for test mode allows
anyone with your database reference to
view and remember database reference i
mentioned that that's inside this
firebase options so that's the reference
that we're talking about okay so it may
sound a little bit abstract but it's
really not that difficult to understand
so
and it says edit and delete all your
database from
all the data in your database for the
next 30 days so okay
and you can see the rule that has been
set up in here says allow read write if
request time is less than blah blah blah
so it's opening up your database
basically for 30 days it's actually
quite intelligent pretty nice okay so i
need you to do that and remember we're
gonna tighten this up soon okay
and then you can see in here it says
allow basically set up a location for
where your data is going to be stored
now there may be some sort of like um
conflict of interest
between like the legal portions of your
business and also where you want to
store your data and where you actually
feel comfortable doing that but and gdpr
definitely makes this even more
complicated if you're living in europe
so
i mean even if you're living abroad gdpr
makes things complicated some websites
that are hosted in the us are still not
accessible by users in the eu
and this makes things a little bit
complicated i'm i'm basically
in
sweden right now so i i prefer to use
maybe a location that is
um
has something to do with europe and uh
i can see europe west while sweden is
kind of like in the middle so i'm just
going to use europe west right now but
again this isn't so so significant right
now it could have
some speed implications for application
depending on where the server actually
is so it's really good that firebase is
giving you the option to choose the
location of your firestore database
so you may want to read more about this
and you can press learn more in order to
read more about this but i'm just going
to pick europe west just because i
believe it it could make more sense for
me since i am located in sweden
so
choose a location that makes sense for
you and then press the enable button
wow that is a an absolutely horrific
looking loading screen
what that is i mean it's not even
centered so that's okay firebase
remember we're using firebase as a free
service so i just want to make sure that
everybody understands i'm very very
thankful for having firebase because
it's made life a lot easier for me
even though i can create my own backends
but i sometimes still prefer to use
firebase so
um just because it's so
it's so easy to use so uh thank you so
much any anybody who's working
on firebase and providing us with free
services
um so
so let's have a look in here um about in
our rules so let me increase the size of
the screen
like this and perhaps also
increase it like this so you see it
better let me see if i can
perhaps
close the section to the left a little
bit and
i probably could actually have done that
so i'm going to go back in here and
press this button to close that section
all right so what we need to do now is
to as the caption indicates we're going
to change the
the security rules in our database
and i change it so that
we allow read and write if the user is
authenticated
um so we make sure you as you can see it
says request off is not null so let's go
ahead and change that so i'm gonna
remove everything after request
dot like this and you can see it gives
you access to off path resource time
method
so i'm just going to say off is not null
okay
so you can actually bring it to the same
line as well if you want to
so after you've done that you can say
allow read write if request auth is not
all and that literally just means that
people who are authenticated with our
application and they have
and they have a valid firebase user when
they interact with the database are
allowed to read and write
read from and write to the database
however remember
this is database wide at the moment it
says any document and we still haven't
talked about documents so much but i'll
tell you soon about that but any just
imagine anything in your database can be
read from and written to if the user is
logged in and that's not so secure
because
that literally means that i as user one
and you as user two have access to each
other's documents okay even if the
application itself is like segregating
these two documents saying that oh
you're user one i'm gonna just give you
user ones documents but internally as a
firebase user
given our current security um
rules
you will have access to my documents
even if the application's limiting your
access just remember that okay
so
after you've done that i need you to
please press the publish button
so as you can see it says publish
changes can take up to a minute to take
effect and that's all right because
we're going to actually take more than a
minute before we jump into using these
new rules in our application so
okay now
let's talk about collections here
um
and i've prepared a doc and a link there
so let me see if i can find that
link here as well
so as you can see in here there is a
good documentation that will talk a
little bit about collections and
documents and you could go through this
um but i'm not gonna do that right now
but just so you know here's the link at
the bottom of the screen if you want to
do that
i'm going to talk about collections
personally so you will understand it in
my words so
at this point what we need is just to go
to our firebase database
okay and what you'll see is a screen
that kind of looks like this so it has
your project name in here and then there
is a button called start collection okay
just imagine collection as its name
indicates is a group of related objects
objects could be you could interpret
them as tables as you traditionally have
in your
relational databases such as sqlite um
so
a collection just imagine for instance
if we say what does our application do
our application stores nodes for
all its users so user a has nodes user b
has nodes but user c may not have nodes
so the only thing our application is
storing in
in database right now is notes so that
could be its own collection okay so we
just create a collection called notes
and in that collection we're gonna store
all our notes okay so
every user is going to have their own
notes
that's how we are going to do it in this
course
however you as a developer may just
think
i'm going to do it differently what i'm
going to do is i'm going to create a new
collection of notes for every user so
user a is going to have a collection
called user a notes
user b is going to have user b notes
or you may just
assign create a collection with every
user id so you remember we get a user
identifier from firebase you may decide
to you create a collection for every
user based on their user id okay that's
fine but if you're following along with
this course i strongly suggest actually
do it the way i'm doing especially if
you if you if it's the first time you're
doing this if it's if you've done this
before you may just be comfortable with
creating
another type of collection then be my
guest please go ahead but it might then
be difficult for you later on to follow
along with the course
okay so
those are collections
so let's go ahead and um
tap the start collection button in here
um as you can see in here it says okay
this collection is being created in the
root path and just give me an id and
here's a collection set of documents
that contain data
and in here it's storing a collection of
users
but remember we don't have to actually
store users in our database firebase is
already taking care of this i actually
believe this is a bad example that they
provided to ask people to say example
collection of users because this kind of
gives id idea to developers oh now i
have to store my users here but those
users are already stored at the firebase
level okay
so let's go and go ahead in here and
just say we're storing nodes okay and
we're just gonna say next
and you can see in here now we're
getting something called a document
parent path
notes and then it says a document id a
collection must contain at least one
document cloud firestore's unit of
storage documents store your data as
fields auto generate a document or the
id or customize one if needed okay
so
that that brings us to what documents
are
um
a document
you could look at it as
if you're if you know about uh
sql from before if you followed along
with what being and what we've been
creating like when we looked at db
browser for sql lite
then we had these tables like user and
notes
these uh
these are like the schemas of a document
so as you can see here and here says
every note
is created this way it has an id it has
a user id it has a text is synced with
cloud remember all those fields and it
has that's the schema
in far in the firestore world those are
documents so that entire notes
schema is one document and every field
in it then it can have a data type so
those fields you may know them as
columns
from before
when we created our own tables okay so
if we go back into db browser
you may not have this db browser for sql
light open and that's completely fine
we're not gonna actually work with it
right now you may have you may even have
like is toss that database in the trash
and that's completely fine i just want
to show you this um
that when we created this node table or
the node documents then we had different
fields remember id user id text and
those were the exact same things in here
okay
so if i if i go ahead and create a new
console firebase
and have a look at for instance my
other uh firebase projects i can see i
have a notes app and you can here see
that um the way i had designed this uh
in the beginning of this course is i had
a collection and then every collection
had documents in it that had text and
then user id okay so that's what we're
gonna do in here we're just gonna say a
field of text
and it's typed string and it has no
value okay and then we're gonna add a
new field in here and just call it use
righty
okay and then in here it has no value
either and then a document id that we're
just gonna auto generate okay so we just
pretty much just created a new note okay
with a random document id and it has a
field of text and another field called
user id
great then i need you to press the save
button and now you'll see here we have
our notes collection and inside there we
have a document that has these two
fields okay
so what you could do also is to delete
either a collection or delete a a
document so i'm just going to say delete
document and start delete and as you can
see now we have an empty collection
called nodes
i still find this a little bit peculiar
that when we create a collection
firebase
forces us to create a document inside it
like if i go and say start collection
and then press the next button in here i
can't actually save my empty collection
and it says every
let's see here a collection must contain
at least one document
so
i'm not sure if that's actually true
because you can see now we have a
collection with no document so
i'm not sure why that was created why
that uh
rule was set when you create a new
collection but just know that it's not
completely true so you can have a
collection with no documents all right
so now let's talk a little about
streams of data if you remember from our
application in if we go to our
i think it's called uh
node service
here
you remember that we have this stream of
database nodes as a stream of list of
database nodes and we call it all nodes
in our application up to this point
we've had to manage these streams
manually in that we have to like go
create a stream controller do this whole
dance of um
unlisten populate the stream controller
with the nodes
you'd be really really happy perhaps to
hear that when we go to firebase and
firestore we don't have to do any of
this because firestore
already has all of this built in in that
when you for instance read all the
documents inside this notes collection
that will actually be a stream of those
uh
data points for you so
no more
stream controller and no more streams
that you have to manage manually okay
those will be exposed to your
application using firestore
so
so as you saw and when i created this
collection to begin with i created it
with
a note document that had a text and it
had a user id field so
our goal in this chapter and going
forward is to make sure that every node
has a text and it is actually linked to
a firebase user using that user's user
id okay
so
if we go to our
application to our auth service so let's
go to off and then auth service in here
and remember we're using firebase auth
provider so let's go in there and you
can see that
when we say create user with email and
password for instance then this function
returned something called user
credential to us and user credential
actually has quite a few properties you
can see it has a credential and it has a
user inside it of type user so if you go
into that user you can see it has
different properties like display name
email email verified metadata phone
number etc but this user also has
something called a user's unique id
which we actually need in order to store
notes into our collect notes collection
so
and this is what i mean every document
that we create is for instance going to
be node some
random id or something which we haven't
decided yet and one of the fields let me
actually see if i can resize uh this
safari window so you see it better so
it's going to have a text and the text
is going to be generated by the user but
it's going to also have a field called
user id okay so in this user id field we
actually need to store that user's
gener
firebase generated id in there okay
and
now going back to
what we are doing with that user do you
remember we're not actually um exposing
the firebase user to our application and
that's a great level of abstraction
however we have a little bit of a
problem in that right now our user has
email and is email verified it doesn't
actually have a unique id so our
application is not going to be able to
associate new notes with
an auth user
it's not going to be able to associate a
new note with a user id okay
so we need to fix that so i'm just going
to go to my notes a little bit in here
and what we need is to
update our auth user as you can see in
here so in
auth user.dart file as i've opened in
here
and what we need is to add a new field
which is a required field and we need to
make that
the
id of that user okay
so let's go ahead and do that now so i'm
just going to go ahead and say final
string
and id so this field is not optional
here you see every user that comes into
our application should have an id and
that's like the expectation that we have
on our off users okay so i need you to
go ahead and add that please here of
user class as well
let's then go in here and i'm going to
add this um to um
the required fields i can see visual
studio code wasn't able to actually meet
this required parameter
i'm going to help visual studio code and
do that i'm just going to say required
this id and i need you to do the same
thing please
so now we have a problem in here in that
our auth user in here doesn't have an
id where we created from firebase user
let's go and remedy that let's just say
the id in here is the user uid remember
this uh parameter that i uh talked to
you about okay
so that is now created and let me
actually go to scrcpy i can see that
visual studio code has a little bit of
problem hot reloading right now so
that's because probably the application
wasn't in the foreground so that's fixed
now
talking about scr cpy it's perhaps a
good idea for me to bring in crcpy here
just to make sure that we're not
bringing and breaking anything okay
so
so that's one change that we have to
make to our auto user the other change
that we have to make is to make sure
that the email parameter of our user is
not optional
you see the way we are creating at the
moment are
um
our application is that we've created
the login process of a use email and
password authentication so we don't have
like facebook authentication or google
authentication we only have username and
password
sorry email and password so
given that condition we can be sure that
every authenticated user in our
application actually has an email
address okay
so
let's go ahead and just say that email
is not an optional field anymore and in
here we're going to explicitly unwrap
that email all right so that's another
change that we made to our application
so now that we've done that you can see
flutter is not so happy with those
changes saying that well yeah you broke
something and it's our tests that have
been broken
so as you can see uh we need to make
sure that id is actually included in our
tests as well
and since we're not actually creating a
specific test for that user id
we can just add a random id in here
let's just say my id okay and i'm going
to bring that and
bring it down here as well so we have an
id field in both cases of auth user
inside our tests
okay now
we have another problem as you can see
in the captions in our create update
note view
we are unwrapping the user's email and
that's what this little orange views um
folder is it's not red
meaning that
well yeah it's not an error but it's a
warning so let's go to this create
update note view
and have a look at this uh
field in here as you can see we're in
inside the get a create or get existing
note
and we are unwrapping this email but
right now the warning is saying what is
it saying the uh uh
asterisk will have no effect because the
receiver can't be not try removing the
asterisk operator and i need you to do
that please
we have another problem also we have
another warning inside the notes of you
and i believe we're doing something
similar in the notes view so let's see
if you can find a warning
[Music]
where is the warning
i actually don't oh here we have the
user email in here as well so i'm just
going to remove the asterisk after that
so i need you to do the same thing
please
okay
now we're gonna get to the juicy parts
of the uh cloud storage integration so
i'm clean i'm basically removing all the
file all the dart um tabs from here i'm
actually not deleting the files i'm
removing like that tab so it's a clean
slate
then what we need is to um
create
all our cloud storage exceptions you see
if you remember from when we worked with
our quad service which is a node service
then we also had a file under the croth
folder called crowd exceptions and in
here we define all the different things
that could go wrong when the user is
working with our node service now that
we're moving away from crud we need to
have our new exceptions defined
somewhere
and and
as you can see in the cache just like we
had the crowd exceptions we're also
going to have some exceptions thrown by
our new fire
firestore service which we haven't
developed yet but we need to define
those exceptions at least okay
so
what we need now is to go and create
that file so i need you to please create
a file under lib services
cloud and then create that file as cloud
storage exception so
i'm going to do that as well so let's
see i'm going to fold all the folders in
here
so we have lib services and then cloud
you can see we don't have cloud at the
moment so we do have services and we
have off in there and crowd so i'm gonna
right click on services and say new file
and then in here i'm just gonna say
cloud
and then slash cloud storage
exceptions.dart
okay
so
after the creation of that file
i'm going to remove the project explorer
there as well what we need then is to
define
a super class for all our cl cloud
exceptions
if you remember from the crowd
exceptions that we created in here
all those exceptions were actually of
type exception and that's one way of
doing that however
if you want to group your
exceptions under one
super
exception
and you could then
handle them quite smoothly or better
actually i would say
in
at the call site and so that basically
is going to use inheritance and then you
and we are going to create a new
exception as you can see
here called cloud storage exception and
all our cloud exceptions are going to be
of that type so makes grouping and
catching these exceptions in the future
a lot easier okay
so let's go ahead and
create our first exception it is called
i can see it's called cloud storage
exception
so let's go ahead and say clouds and
class cloud storage exception
and implements exception
okay
and we're also going to create a
constant constructor for it so it makes
creating instance of this a lot easier
and you could also
basically say that this is um an
immutable class meaning that this class
and all its subclasses need to be
immutable you could do that all right
that's fine as well but usually
exceptions aren't marked with this it's
usually data classes that are marked
with immutable so i'm not gonna do that
right now
okay that thing is done um
now so that's the parent exception we
should try not to throw that exception
as it is we have to throw subclass
subclasses of that exception okay
now
the first exception that we're going to
define is could not create node
exception i believe it's called yes and
we're going to throw this in our
to be written a class soon uh upon you
trying to create a new note if firebase
firestore is not able to actually create
that note then we're gonna throw this
error okay
so i'm gonna then define that exception
and you will need to type this then um i
just brought it from my notes
now also in this screen where we have
all the notes displayed for a given user
we may also not be able to retrieve all
the notes for that user for instance if
there is a network connection issue or
whatever whatever other issues that may
arise
so we need to have an exception for that
as well and that exception is called
could not get all nodes exception okay
so let's define that as well
and it's written just like could not get
all notes exceptions exception
the next exception that we have to
define is called a could not update
nodes so we have create node exception
get node exception and now we're on the
u part of crot so
you see the
create part is a c in crud gets is
r and now we're looking at you okay
and that is uh
could not update node exception so
so we could say
this is um
you in crud
and the get
is r in crop
and create a c in crud okay and so we
have c r u and then we have to define
d
which is for delete infrared
and that's exactly what we're going to
do now so let's go define could not
delete node exception all right so
let's then say
be in crop okay so now we have
um three four uh exceptions defined and
all of those exceptions are uh
inheriting from cloud storage exception
okay um
now that we've talked about the
exceptions we also have to talk about
the actual cloud storage service you see
we have our quad service at the moment
which we've been working quite a lot
with and we're very proud of it actually
it's a lot of code in my implementation
at least in here we have about
360 lines of code
i mean it's not all code there there's
also spaces there's like
i think there are some annotations like
immutable etc but there's quite a lot of
code okay and there's a print statement
in here which i actually have to remove
okay
so
there's quite a lot of code and this is
working with sql lite but we also need a
service that works with firebase
firestore
so we need to create that service soon
so just know that we are going to have
crud in here which is going to talk with
sqlite
but we're moving actually away from it
so
let's then fix that
um
so let's go in here and have a look at
our constants
and if you look at our node servicing
here
and we have our
constants in here we have routes and at
the end of node service we have some
constants defined right in this class
or right in this dart file
and some people may like this but i
personally prefer to have my constants
defined in separate files even though
these constants are
very related only to this file but just
making them putting them in separate
places just makes it easier to look at
because these constants at the moment
like hidden at the bottom very bottom of
this file
so let's go ahead and define our
constants so let's have a look at the
path it's going to be in services cloud
and then cloud storage constants
on the services now we have cloud
and under cloud we have cloud storage
exceptions i think exceptions yep now we
have to define cloud storage constants
so new file cloud storage
constants dart
and
i'm going to go to my notes
[Music]
constants all right
now if you remember from our note series
we define like the tables and
excuse me
and we defined the tables the columns
and and even the format of creating new
tables we don't really need these all we
need are these two fields as you
remember the
text and also we need a field for user
id like this
so let's define these let's just say
owner user id so let's go in here and
say const
increase the size owner user
id is just user id like this and then
we're gonna say const text field name
excuse me so i need you to define these
two fields as well for your application
okay
so let's go back to the original font
size in there
so
now that we've defined that if you
remember from our note service we had
these beautiful classes in here a call
called a database node and a database
user now
given that we're moving away from
storing
things and notes inside the sqlite
database and we're moving to towards a
firestore um
databases
we actually don't need a database user
anymore
but we do need some sort of a class that
represents these documents that we're
going to create in here okay and
what we are going to call that is called
a cloud node
so let's go ahead you see here is called
a database node so then you kind of know
that it is a local database maybe you
could rename this local database node if
you want to but i'm not going to do that
simply because we're moving away from
this so what's the point of refactoring
it so
i'm going to close node service so then
let's go ahead and create a new file
called cloud note dart under services
lib services cloud
and i'm going to call it cloud
underscore node.dark
in here now what we need to do is
actually implement cloud nodes
excuse me
so
what a cloud node actually is going to
contain there are three properties that
the cloud node has to contain
and they're namely the
actual identifier of that node and i
apologize i actually have to put myself
into do not disturb so
so
there are three things a cloud node has
to contain
one is the actual like primary key of
that note in our database every document
that is generated by firebase
is going to have a unique id if you're
coming from like backend development
then you're already familiar with this
for instance django has this idea of a
pk which is primary key you can also
read it as id so everything that's
stored in the database has some sort of
a primary key
firestore is no different so every
document that is created inside a
firestore database is also going to have
a primary key okay
so that's the first property that our
cloud node is going to contain
the other two are very familiar because
you saw here in the documents we're
gonna have a text field and the other
one is like the owner user id so there
are three fields that we have to add to
our class so let's go ahead and do that
let's just say
um if i can type here
so class sorry i have a microphone right
in front of my face like it's blocking
my keyboard so that's sometimes that's
why i have to like look like this just
to find my keyboard
so let's say cloud node
um
and inside our cloud node let's define
these three properties so let's just say
final string
document id okay
and i'm going to copy the string here as
well and say owner user id and then
we're going to say text okay
help from visual studio code to
implement the constructor
and um in here then i'm going to say
this is a constant constructor okay as i
said you could actually go and define
this as immutable which i actually
prefer in this case to be honest with
you i hadn't i hadn't planned to make
this immutable but i think actually
makes sense if it's a cloud node then
let's just say it's immutable okay
so that's that's the first part and i
also know that we need to make these
required parameters so let's go ahead
and do that let's just say required
before all of these parameters okay so
that they're actually required named
parameters
that are not optional basically
okay that's that
if you look at how our database nodes
let's see if we can find database node
inside nodes service
so let's have a look at database node do
you remember that we had these fields
but we're pretty much never calling this
database nodes a constructor we're
always using this thing database node
from row
and this is basically the object you
just see this map is the object that
we're reading from our sqlite database
and crew and then we're internally
creating instances of our database node
from that object okay
so
this kind of map is what you will also
receive from
firestore
however it's going to be wrapped inside
something called a query document
snapshot so it's just a wrapper
around your data so
let's go ahead in here and and what
we're going to say is if you just type
query document snapshot then
visual studio code is going to import
this automatically for you okay so
then it should be imported in here so
that's great
and also we need our um
cloud storage constants so let's go and
import those as well so let's just say
package and my nodes and we have uh what
do we have
where is this stored inside services
cloud so services cloud
constant or sorry
cloud storage constants so
you need cloud firestore dart and then
your constants as well
let's go ahead and create kind of like a
constructor that we are going to call
from snapshot and this constructor is
going to allow firestore to give us a
snapshot of it and cloud nodes and then
we're going to create an instance of our
cloud node from that okay so let's just
say cloud node from
from snapshot
and parameter is going to be query
document snapshot that has that map that
we actually need
like this and we're going to call it
snapshot like that okay
so
now you can see that we're getting some
errors from um
from dart saying all final variables
need to be initialized and a function
body must be provided okay we're going
to fix it soon so this is this is the um
signature of your function then in here
your job now is to make sure that all
your fields are initialized so let's
let's just say if i can type again
document id
it comes from our snapshot id
that's a property that is stored on this
at the snapshot level so you can get
that id okay
and what we're going to say is that we
have an owner user id that we also have
to fill in so that comes from the
snapshot
uh snap
shot
data
and in there then we have to say the
owner
user id field name let's see owner user
id
under user id let's call this field name
so sorry about that let's go back to the
cloud storage constants and fix this to
say owner user id field name actually
okay
so we missed that but that's okay it's
just a naming change so
then we're gonna say owner user id field
name
so that's for the owner user
id and we're going to get the text which
is equal to snapshot dot
data
and text field name
as string
okay so what we have is a beautiful
cloud node immutable class with a
constant constructor and also we get
this snapshot um query document snapshot
from firestore soon and we can create
instances of our cloud nodes as you'll
soon see
all right now what we need um
is to create our new cloud firestore
service
so this is like the beginning of moving
away from cloud storage into firestore
so this is actually very exciting and a
little bit um
a little bit intimidating maybe at first
because well we kind of have to like
redo quite a lot of work
but given that firestore provides you
with pretty much all the tools that you
need as you'll soon see the
implementations of the functions that
we're gonna that we're gonna do are so
minimal because the base is there fire
stores already provided the base we just
have to hook into it and grab the data
write the data etc so
so let's close all these tabs that we
have at the moment
excuse me and let's go to this um
services cloud and create our new
firebase cloud storage dart file
firebase cloud storage
dart
all right so
i'm actually going to do that as well so
firebase
cloud storage
in my notes all right
so let's go ahead and say we have a new
class called firebase cloud storage
like that
at the moment it doesn't do really
anything but what we need to do uh is to
make uh make this
a shared instance
and
i'm gonna bring the caption for that and
if you remember we've already made our
node service
a
a singleton so let's go back to our node
service
command p on macintosh and visual studio
code or control p in
windows and linux to bring up this
search files by name field and i'm just
going to say note service
if you remember inside note service i
think
at the top we had this pattern
for creating a singleton do you remember
this
right
so we kind of need or sorry this part we
kind of need the same thing
not kind of actually pretty much exactly
the same thing except for this part
because this talks with a stream
controller so i find this pattern of
creating singletons in dart still quite
hacky i think i've mentioned this before
when we created the node service
but it's something that we have to do so
make sure our firebase cloud storage is
actually a singleton okay so i'm gonna
bring that code from my notes because i
don't think it's actually worth writing
this and it's not worth your time or my
time
but this is what you need to create so
what is happening in here is that we
have a private constructor
then we're going to create a factory
constructor which is the default
constructor of our of our class firebase
cloud storage right here
and that is going to talk with a static
final field which in turn calls this
private
initializer so
in um in other languages like swift and
rust it's it's a lot easier to create a
singleton but this is a pattern you have
to do so
first create a private constructor then
create a factory constructor that talks
with a static final which in turn talks
with the private constructor okay
okay after you've taken care of that
what we need to do is to grab all our
notes from
our cloud storage okay
so let's just go ahead after this
factory constructor we're gonna expose a
field as the note as the caption at the
bottom of the screen in the case call
notes
so i'm just going to say notes equal to
we're just going to say firebase and
firestore and it's going to auto import
it for me so this is not a strange thing
anymore to you as well
and then i'm just going to say our own
instance and then
excuse me a collection called notes
quotes as well
okay
so this is how you actually talk with a
firestore so you can see that the
signature of this collection is actually
returning use something called a
collection reference
and you will soon see how we can extract
our actual notes from this collection
all right
and also remember
this isn't gonna work if you haven't
actually created your notes collection
so if you haven't done that if you
forgot to do that please go ahead
excuse me to go ahead and do that right
now
so the first thing we need to do is to
create a function for creating new nodes
all right
excuse me
so let's go ahead um into our project
and create a function as the
caption indicates i'm going to say void
create new nodes in here
and then we're going to say we need a
an owner id
so required string owner user id i
believe we call it and then it's an
async function okay
and then in here since you have
like a stream or a read write stream uh
of all your notes and that's what this
uh
collection reference means it's it's not
only a stream that you can read from but
also it's a stream you can write to
that's why that's why it's not called a
stream okay
because the stream is like you try to
read only from it so
and in here what we're gonna do is going
to say notes add
and you can see it literally says give
me a map or a dictionary or however you
want to call it
an object that has keys and values
what do you want me to store in a
database and that's what nosql kind of
means in here is document based it's it
has no real structure of what you're
adding everything that you add in here
is going to be packaged into a document
that is going to be stored in here with
the fields and the values that you
specified in here okay
so let's go ahead and say we provide you
with a
with a document in here and the first
field is owner user id field name and
that's gonna auto import it from our
constants from before remember
and in here the value of this is going
to be the owner user id
and
the text field
text
field
name is just going to be an empty note
for now okay and remember this is an
async asynchronous function which
returns a future of a document reference
just like we have our collection
reference in here but we actually don't
want its results right now at least so
we're just gonna wait on it so don't
forget that weight because without doing
the weight this function is not actually
going to be invoked
wow okay um
what we need to do now then is to go to
the next item
excuse me which is
getting notes by user id so the
signature is going to be it's going to
return an i
of cloud note
you given a user id so
as we said every
every node we store in our database uh
is gonna have these two fields an owner
and a text field so now what we want is
to grab all the nodes for a specific
user okay
so let's go ahead and do that so it's
called
um get notes and it's quite a meaty
function actually i can see in here
so let's go ahead and do that right now
let's say future of iterable um of cloud
nodes and i think we have to import
cloud node as well so pressing this
button imports this for me if you're
getting some errors it's probably
because your editor hasn't been able to
find cloud nodes so
and then we're going to say get notes
and a required parameter in here
under user id okay and it's an
asynchronous function so like that
so what we're going to do then is to um
a weights
uh on our
on our notes in here you see we can
actually retrieve notes from our notes
collection in here by saying notes where
so we're gonna do a search inside the
notes uh
collection reference and that and you do
that using the where clause okay
and these things could actually increa
like create an exception i believe the
word clause could actually throw an
exception whether it was this one
it's not documenting here but i do
believe that it could actually create an
exception
so let's go ahead and catch this so
let's just say try we're gonna try and
then should anything happen in here
uh we're just gonna throw
and could
not get all nodes exception and this is
going to auto import that from our
previous code so i i shouldn't explain
this over and over again you know
already how that works okay
so now that we have that we have a try
and catch statement in there so let's
just say we await on the notes
and we say uh where clause and the word
clause is
going to say okay
what is the field that you want to do
your work search on and we want to
search for all notes that are for this
owner user id so let's just say owner
user id field name
should be equal to you see that's the
parameter is equal to owner user id like
that okay
waiting on it you see sorry after doing
a word this gives you a query but then
you need to actually execute this query
and you do that using its get function
and you see it returns
and
let me see gets if i move my mouse over
you see it returns a future of a query
snapshot with all the objects that
firestore could retrieve from the
database okay
so we have to get um
what we do then is to
do then
that's that's how we work with future so
event clause of the future allows you to
return it what it does is it returns the
value of that future to you and it
allows you to return either a
synchronous value inside the then
function or you could actually return
another future
those who are familiar with node.js or
just javascript in general
or even swift they're familiar with how
promises and how futures work so this is
your chance of actually returning a
value given this
future that is returned to you okay
so we're going to call this basically
value at the moment and if i move my
mouse over this you can see it says a
query snapshot of these um
potentially written
red documents
so in here what we're going to do is say
docs which is all the documents that
could be read
and we're going to map all those and you
can see in here
if i call this doc
if i move my mouse over it so it creates
document snapshot whereas this one was a
query snapshot this one is a query
document snapshot of those fields okay
so let's go in here and what we're going
to do is to say we return
inside this return a cloud node
and we have these three fields okay we
have the document id owner user id and
the text
so it's our chance basically to create
an instance of our cloud node right now
i'm gonna put the
columns here so we get the formatting a
little bit better
and what we need to do is to get the
document id and the way to do that is
this dock has an id in here you can see
it's a string so
and the other one is to dock
and then we have the data
and let's just say owner user id field
name
and
that's a string
and in here we're gonna say then a doc
data
and we say text field name
as a string now remember this looks very
familiar where have we done this before
yeah we've done this in cloud notes from
snapshot
and don't worry we're actually gonna use
that function as soon we're gonna remove
this return statement the way it's
written but let's just write it like
this right now okay so it's easier to
understand
wow all right um
i think i think that should be it
and so we have that
excuse me
and um
yeah i believe i believe this is going
to cover it for us right now so not much
more to explain about this to be honest
so
we could also put a comma here
to
make the code a little bit more readable
and we have the value then
return
and what we don't have to be honest with
you here is this return statement in
here
or actually we created this
like this so yeah it's an arrow function
so we don't have to have a special
return statement but if you don't like
this kind of an arrow function you can
grab your code that you've written up to
this point like this
and create
curly brackets in here and instead use
this syntax to say return
instead okay so
it kind of depends on what you prefer um
i don't have a preference and i could
use an error function the way it is so
i'm just going to leave it like this
okay
and remember we're at the moment
awaiting on this but we're not returning
it so let's just return so this is all
basically just a fancy way of us
excuse me communicating with firebase
firestore and reading documents and
there's so much to explain that i can't
go through all of these but i really
suggest that you play with these
functions yourself read the
documentations and see why is it that
i'm using where and then get
so uh for that you need to read all the
documentations
that come with these functions so you
understand them better
okay um
so that's getting notes by user id
now what we need is also
um
[Music]
what we need is
the ability for
us to be able to provide our notes list
in here with a stream of notes for that
particular user okay so
um as you as you know now in our note
service the way we have it is we are
exposing this stream of list of database
node and that's what we kind of also
need to do with our firebase cloud
storage like have a function that our
nodes list
excuse me can't subscribe to and read
all the available nodes for that given
user so let's go ahead and do that let's
just call it a stream iterable
and i have that function signature so i
don't think i should actually write it
manually but you may need to write it so
so that's a function signature okay
and in here what we're going to say is
that we're going to go to our notes
collection in here and get all the
available snapshots
let's see we have our notes and then we
have our snapshots
and we're gonna map that and
let's just say yep
gonna get our documents inside that
snapshot
and then we're gonna
map that
like that and let's just call it doc
and in here we're gonna create a cloud
note from snapshots
of that doc like that
and then in here
we're going to say where
that's our note
and then we're going to say the notes
owner user id i'm gonna actually write
this and then i'm gonna tell you what
i'm basically doing because there's
quite a lot of code in here and like
pausing to describe every little bit of
this code could actually make it look
more complicated than it is so
and i'm just gonna then say owner user
id
okay
but a
semicolon there wait a minute
this ends there and then a semicolon
there yeah so let's see what is
happening in here so this looks actually
quite intimidating to look at but it's a
very simple piece of code so
what we're doing in here is if you want
to grab a stream of data as it is
evolving you want to be able to
subscribe to all the changes happening
to it then you need to use something
called the snapshots as you can see this
is a stream of query snapshot whereas
where is a query itself okay and then
get
is a future so it just the get one
literally takes a snapshot at that point
in time and returns it to you but if you
want to like keep hold of
like if you want to be updated about all
the changes live as they're happening to
your data in the notes collection then
you need to subscribe to the snapshots
that's what we're doing okay so that's
that first part with snapshots so we're
literally saying that we want to see all
the changes as they're happening live
okay
then it says okay i will give you all
the changes that are happening live and
that comes inside the query snapshot
remember query snapshot from here
remember query here
oops inside the get
so
after this point is it's literally what
we did in the get notes it's saying that
okay here is a query snapshot and then
we're saying okay there are documents in
there and that's exactly what we're
doing in here there's documents in the
query snapshot and then we're mapping
every document to a cloud note all right
and then we're putting and where clause
at the end
that says we're only interested in notes
whose u owner user id is the owner user
id provided in here so without this word
clause we're literally exposing all the
notes um
to the current user for all users in the
system so that word clause is very
important okay
so and this work clause as you can as
you can see it is actually inside
flutter bin lip core iterable so that's
nothing that is it's not a function that
firestore has provided for us okay
wow that was
that was a lot of information
okay let's go ahead and talk about
updating you notes sorry updating
existing notes so as we talked about it
before if you have a note and you tap on
it the way it works in our application
right now is i can tap on this node and
go and change its text like 22 and come
back out and now it's changed to 22 okay
so we need to also expose this
functionality
excuse me
in inside our firebase cloud storage um
as well so the function is going to be
update node and it's going to take two
parameters document id and a text so
let's just say
it's going to be a future of void and
we're going to call it update node
two parameters in here which are
required i'm going to say required
string
and document id
and then required string
text
and let's make this an async function
all right then what we're going to do is
we're going to put a try and catch in
here in case we can't update the
notes and then here we're just going to
say throw could not update note
exception okay and you may actually
ignore this e if you want to as well so
you could just do like this
or you could just yeah i think actually
we can't do an empty cache catch so you
may do like this if you prefer but i
prefer to do it like this
all right and i can see that the
formatting is a little bit messed up in
here so i'm going to put a
comma in there
and inside the try statement in here now
what we need to do is to
go to our collections again in here and
let's just say we get a doc you can see
it says okay what is the path of that
doc
and we're going to say the document id
is a path
and then let's then go ahead and say
um dot update
and it says okay what is the actual
update and inside the update what we're
gonna do is gonna say
text field name
is this text all right
so this may look a little bit crypt now
also we have to wait on it may look a
little bit cryptic in the what is doc
dock id
remember inside this function in here it
says give me the path you see this
parameter path
and what we said is that inside the
notes collection every document is going
to have an identifier so we actually are
going to go with the document id which
we instantiated in here do you remember
doc id is going to go into our cloud
node document id so that's the path is
notes slash that document id so that's
how far firebase firestore it called and
basically keeps hold of its paths it's
the the path is in this case if i create
a collection you see it says oh the
collection is being created in the root
folder and it has a collection id which
in our case is called notes and we refer
to it here so we've already constructed
the notes path and every document inside
it has its own id so it's going to be
slash notes slash document id all right
so i hope and i'd explain it for you
let's now talk about deleting notes um
so
deleting notes actually very easy as
well so we don't have to do so much with
deleting nodes so
it's very similar to updating nodes and
we're just going to go ahead and use
document id for deleting notes so
as the caption indicates create a new
feature of void in here and we're going
to say delete node and we're going to go
ahead and use a required string
parameter called document
id
it sync and let's just do a try cache in
here in case we can't delete the
document and then we're going to say
throw
could
not
no
notes exception i believe it's called
yeah
inside the
try statement in here
we are going to say notes
doc
with that document id
all right
and then we're just going to say delete
i remember i believe this is actually
future void so let's just wait on it all
right so
that's really all you have to do for
delete so there's no magic in that it's
very similar to update note except that
it's not taking care of any like fields
or anything like that
wow huge huge chapter we've talked a lot
about now uh about firestore and
firebase storage so
thank you so much for for sticking with
me throughout this chapter and but if
you remember i mean if you look at what
we've done is not so much code it's 68
lines of code for me it may be less for
you if you haven't
done all these extra commas in here so
maybe like 60
but there's a lot of new concepts so
i thought that i had to
i took the liberty of maybe even over
explaining things
but i think in the beginning it's very
important just to understand how
everything works
um
okay
so great job we've done what we promised
to do in this chapter we have actually
tested to make sure that this is this is
working we're gonna do this in the next
chapter but as it's tradition we're
gonna make sure that our work is
committed to our uh
github repository or bitbucket wherever
you're using your uh or wherever you're
hosting your git project so let's go
ahead and do that
i want to change the screen um
layout a little bit i'm going to get rid
of scrcpy
oops
and i'm going to close the screen
make this
bigger in this uh view and then i'm
going to go to terminal okay
excuse me let's have a look at our
status there's quite a bit modified in
here and also we've added a whole new
folder so i'm just going to say git add
all
and let's have a look at our log the
previous commit was step 18 and let's
have a look at our tags i can see step
18 here as well
let's commit now let's say let's say
step 19
excuse me again
and then we have
commits
and we've committed and let's push those
changes
let's also tag and say step 19 in here
okay
and let's push our tags as well
all right that's that
as again is tradition at the end of
every chapter we'll talk about what we
have to discuss in the next chapter
and as you can see it says uh we need to
start using our new service instead of
sqlite database so that's a little bit
of a
um like a turning point in our whole uh
course in that we're gonna like toss our
local storage and go away from that and
start using our firebase cloud storage
and so
uh it's it's i think the next chapter is
actually one of the most exciting
chapters
excuse me in this whole course so
grab some refreshments if you want to
and i'll see you there
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 37
of this flutter course as you've seen in
previous chapters we've started to move
away from our local database storage and
that was on sqlite and we started going
more and more towards using firestore
databases that are hosted by firebase so
that was a very exciting point in our um
in this course basically and for me as
well as the as your instructor to go
over to
a cloud storage rather than using local
uh storage and you see we used crud and
as i mentioned in the previous chapter i
really wanted to
introduce you to crowd because it's such
an important part of software
development that you will sooner or
later need to use crowd storage locally
on your computer on your applications so
um
that was basically done
on purpose so we first talked about
local storage and then we move away from
it
and simply because uh even firebase in
itself is some sort of a crud storage
not some sort of it is crud but it is
stored on the cloud and concepts of crop
would have been a lot bit more difficult
for me to explain to you had me not
first implemented implemented them
locally so
um
in the previous chapter we prepared our
service which we i will bring the code
here so we can have a look we we
actually called it let's see
it's inside our services cloud we call
it firebase cloud storage
right here and um
we also talked about how we can
basically start integrating in
this firebase cloud search in our
application and this is the chapter that
we're gonna
um
make those plans concrete okay
if you follow the chapters
from the beginning chronologically in
this course you'll know that what i like
to do when i try to refactor things is
to cut things from the source and by
that i mean now we want to get rid of
our local crud storage and what i like
to do as a strategy is to go to
uh the application and like either
comment out that entire piece of code
which has to do with our note service
and the crowd exceptions
or
either we cut it out completely or we
commented out okay
so let's go ahead and deal with that now
so i'm gonna change the screen layout a
little bit here and i'm then gonna go
into our notes service so please go to
the note service and select the entire
code in here and comment it out
so that's for note service and then
we're also going to go to our i'm going
to save this file and then we're going
to go to crowd exceptions select the
entire content and comment it out please
so that's that
um another thing that we need to take
care of is um inside our new firebase
cloud storage inside uh get's notes what
we forgot to do is where i actually
didn't forget to do i intentionally left
it like this so that we could get the
basic idea is as you can see here we we
are inside this uh get notes function as
the caption indicates at the bottom of
the screen we are returning an instance
of our cloud node use using its
constructor its default constructor
however if you remember from this cloud
node snapshot we have
a convenient constructor that can create
an instance of our cloud node using a
document snapshot and that's exactly
what we're getting in here you see query
document snapshot but we're not using
that convenient constructor and that's
exactly what we're going to fix
right now so
excuse me
let's go in here where we have the dock
and i'm going to change this code to go
from a normal function to an error
function and then in here i'm gonna say
we return a cloud node from snapshot of
that dock okay just like that
i press s to save this file command
sorry and you can also remove that comma
at the end so you either leave it like
this with a comma at the end so it
becomes multi-line or you remove the
comma like i do in here and it just
becomes one line all right
okay
that part is done
now what we need to do um is to
be inside this
firebase cloud storage and you can see
in here
inside the functionality uh sorry inside
the create new node at the moment we're
saying void so we're not returning the
node that we're actually creating and we
need to fix this so
we need to actually create the new new
node and return it so let's go in here
and i'm just going to say final
make the code a little bit bigger
final
document is equal to a weight
on this
and if you look at your document now
you can see it is a document actually
you may not be able to see it now you
can see it probably it is a document
reference okay so it's a reference as
its name indicates is not the snapshot
in order to get the snapshot we need to
just issue the get function on it
so let's just say final fetched note is
a wait
on this document get
and you'll see now fetch note is the
actual snapshot that will contain the
data of that document all right
so in here we will just return a cloud
node
like this
or
let's see cloud node with these
parameters
the document id is going to be the
fetched note
id
the owner user user id is provided to
our function already and the text is
just going to be empty like this and
also make sure that uh in here we don't
return void except we return a future of
cloud nodes okay
so
save your file after that and this
part's also done
okay
um
now
we need to make sure just i'm just gonna
close uh all these tabs and as the
caption indicates we're gonna go to our
create update notes view and fix that up
so it can
talk with our new service which is the
cloud firebase storage i think we call
it firebase cloud storage sorry about
that
so i'm going to press command p in
visual studio code on mac or control p
and linux and windows and then just say
create what's it called
create update node view okay
and here as the caption indicates we
need to import three things our
cloud node dart file
the cloud storage exceptions dark file
and the firebase cloud storage dart
files so those are at the moment inside
the um
let's see they're inside services cloud
folder
so i'm going to go in here i'm just
going to say import package my nodes and
then services
cloud
so we have first cloud node so let's
import that
i'm going to copy this path and then use
it again to import cloud storage
exceptions
like that and then we also need cloud
what's it called firebase cloud storage
like that so that's
you will need to also do these three
imports if you haven't called your
application my notes then this package
is going to be different it's going to
be packaged the name of your application
and then services etc etc okay
okay
um
the next thing that we have to do as you
can see in the captions here
we need to make sure that our create
update node views state which is right
here which at the moment contains our
node service as its node service it has
to move towards using the firebase cloud
storage
so i'm going to go to my notes as well
in here just to make sure i'm giving you
all the information that you need so
let's change our node service in here
and call it now firebase cloud storage
and that's the service okay
and in your init function then you need
to also make sure that we get the
singleton instance of our firebase cloud
storage in the init state function all
right
also remember this note now is not a
database note anymore but it's actually
a cloud node so let's call that cloud
node as well all right
and and now we can see we have an unused
import in here so i'm just going to
remove that since we don't need that
unused import
then the next thing we need to do is as
a caption in the case we have to go to
create or get existing node and we have
to make sure that it works with the
cloud storage so let's go in here
perfect
so in here
we're not going to return a database
node anymore and we're going to say it
returns a cloud node
and here we expect a parameter of type
cloud nodes optionally that can be
passed to our routes
and here we're not going to be working
with
you see here we were working with
database users before because our
application was actually creating new
users in the local database and
associating notes with those users
thankfully that now that we're going to
now that we're using firestore um
database we don't have to play with
users anymore because remember users are
already managed by firebase
so
what we can do is just remove that owner
completely
and now we await on our node service and
we just say create new node and then we
need an owner user id and remember this
owner user id is going to be the actual
current user's user id so let's just say
final user id is current user
dot id okay
and then in here we just say user id
okay and we're storing that note in here
as we were doing before so we didn't
change that code at all and then we're
seeing new notes also need to be
returned
so now we need to fix the creation of
our new node and that's something that
we've already done so that there
shouldn't be a separate point really in
the caption so we've already done that
nothing to take care of right now
we also need to take care of now our
deleting a notes you remember when we go
out out of the
node creation view if the node's text
was empty we actually delete that node
from the database okay right now and now
we need to go towards our node service
and also delete it by using the new
function which is called delete node
and let's see what it takes as a
parameter it takes a document id
and that's our node's document id okay
so that's for delete note and
now we have another function very useful
function that saves the notes and when
we go out of the screen if the if that
note
if the text for that note is not empty
very similar to delete node but it kind
of does the opposite make sure that the
node is present and also that the text
to the text editing controller is set if
it's not
not empty meaning that the text is set
then we update the current node so let's
then await on it and in here we just say
update node
those new parameters
the document id is going to be our notes
document id
and the text in here let's see
oh we have to just put a comma in there
and then we're good to go
so that's updating the save node if text
not empty function
okay
now we need to go to our note list view
and i'm going to do the same thing in my
notes
excuse me
and let's go ahead and do that
do we have any errors in here yes i can
see i'm getting an error for update note
and i don't really know what the problem
actually is let's see
document id is required okay and i can
see that this is something also we need
to update so let's go to your text
controller listener function as well and
update
the note there as well you can see it's
doing this so
now we now have to say update note
and we have a note document id and then
we've got text so please ensure that
you're you've taken care of the text
controller listeners functionality as
well
um
and i'm just making sure that that's
exactly what we've done in my notes as
well all right
so that that was one step back um now
let's go and do what the caption at the
bottom screen says let's go to our notes
list view um
notes list view and as you can see at
the moment we're working with a list of
database notes and we don't want to do
this anymore we actually want to work
with iterables because that's like the
default way that firebase actually works
it works with eye troubles it doesn't
work with lists so
and iterables are actually better
because they're like lazy lists so let's
change this to an iterable of a cloud
node like this and also we change our
node callback to be a cloud node
if i can spell and also we have to also
import this so i'm just going to import
cloud node so that error is going to go
away i'm going to remove this uh import
statement from there
now when you're using eye troubles you
can't do a subscript like we're doing in
here you have to say object element at
and then you have your index and that's
pretty much what we're doing in here so
now if you've made this change in your
node callback you made this change from
list to iterable and you change this
from database node to cloud node and
also change this function from a
subscript to element add then you
shouldn't have any errors in your notes
listview.dart file either
now we're going to go to a little bit
juicier changes that we have to make to
ensure that our application works as
expected with the cloud
storage
let's go to notes view
notes view like here and you'll see now
um
actually i can see my notes here uh
we have to do a few updates in here
because we're not going to work with
node service anymore since it doesn't
exist
but one bigger change that we have to
make
is as you can see in the cash offset
remove the future builder
why is that here is the future builder
the way it is today
you can see the future builders actual
future is to get or create a user but do
we really need that anymore
and the answer is obviously no because
previously we were using this feature
builder to create a user in our database
so that we can associate notes with that
user
however since now we're going towards
firestore and uh
cloud storage the users like users in
your application are managed by firebase
itself so you don't have to
create them in that sense when a user
has logged in and landed on the main
interface of your application that
firebase user already exists so you
don't have to do anything so we need to
remove this future builder so i'm just
going to press command dot on it and
sometimes visual studio code can
actually help with that to remove it but
it's not helping at the moment
so what i'm going to do in this case as
you can see i want to just grab this
stream builder in here
just grab the stream builder without the
return statement okay
and find the end of that stream builder
visual studio code is helping me very
nicely with this line in here and saying
this is the end of stream builder so i'm
literally just
gonna do that and cut it okay so now
what you should be ending up with is
your future builder like that looks like
this and then i'm gonna basically kill
that future builder like this okay so
then paste your stream builder
in the place that your future builder
was before so now your body
the body of your um
of your scaffold should just be the
stream builder okay so basically we just
got rid of the future builder all right
so that was that what we need to do then
is to make sure also in here that we're
not using that that we're not exposing a
user email you see from now on when we
create and notes read notes et cetera
we're going to use a user id the user's
identifier so we're not going to work
with our um with the email so
i'm also going to go to my note sorry
about that so um
as the caption at the bottom of the
screen indicates let's go and change
this to user id
and we're just gonna go off service
firebase current user and then we're
gonna get the id okay so that's our user
id
and the rest now is kind of history we
need to ensure that this
view now works with our
new node service so let's remove this
import from here
and now let's say this note service it
is a firebase cloud storage so we're
going to say firebase cloud storage
and in here we just add that and
initialize that we say firebase cloud
storage which is uh
if you remember correctly um it is now a
singleton so we're not creating new
instances basically by doing this
although it looks like we're doing that
so inside our stream builder now what
we're gonna do is not gonna say all
notes anymore like that we're going to
say
all notes
but we're going to pass the owner user
id and that owner user id remember we're
storing it as a getter call user id
and for all our notes in here remember
this all notes is going to give us an
eye trouble if i move my mouse over
there you can see it's an eye trouble of
cloud node so it's not a list anymore so
let's say i trouble
and it's a cloud node in here
okay
and
i can i can see it's complaining that
cloud node can't be found so i'm going
to import cloud node like that
upon deleting in here we also need to
make sure that we call the new one that
says delete node and in this case we
just say
node.document id
all right
so
so that is that seems to be working fine
but what we got here is a subtype of
type firebase cloud storage node service
and we're getting that in
where are we getting that error let's
see if we can find that
in here node 2 and that's okay and
that's because we probably don't have to
do a hot restart and doing a hot restart
could kill my scr cpy and i can see that
it did that but that's fine too i'm
gonna bring up scr cpy
like this
and
i'm gonna
do this and i'm gonna run the
application now from scratch and this is
simply because i mean this is a state
management in your application because
we had a node service from before and we
do a hot hot reload but hot reload all
of a sudden says oops
this node service that used to be node
service is not node service anymore it's
a firebase cloud storage so what should
i do with it so it's just
it's like
state residue that is kind of like
staying in your application and you
can't clean it until you do a hot
restart and when i did a hot restart i
have a problem with scr cpy
so i can't i can't do anything about
that problem but let's just run the
application from scratch and just make
sure everything is working as expected
all right now i can see that i've logged
into the application and i have no notes
all right
let me bring up the caption for the next
uh
topic to talk about so what we need now
you can see notes have disappeared and
this is a good sign because that kind of
means that we have moved away from our
crotch storage and now we're not reading
those notes that were in the crotch
storage anymore
so let's go and create some notes so i
want to press the plus button in here
and i'm just going to say note
number one so if i press the back button
in here i can see that node number one
is appearing here and let's go create
another one and let's say note number
two
great note number one and number two if
i press this number two and then change
it to note number three you can see that
those changes are immediately taking
effect okay
so let me log out from this user and
let's log in with i don't know really
which user i was logged in with before
i'll log in with this user i can see
that user has no notes i'm just going to
say
van dot's first note
go out and then say run dots
second note
and go out so now if i log out from this
one.user in here and if i say i want to
log in with another user
so like this
i can see my note one and three are
displayed here so i can just say note
number one and two
and if i log out from this user
and log in again with vanbot i should be
able to see van dot's
notes
through barbaz
great so that seems to be working now
what we could do i mean if you're just
like me and you're curious how this data
is actually stored in firebase we could
do that so let me open up a window in
here and say console
and let's go ahead into our project on
firebase console and let's go in
our database
and let's have a look in here as you can
see there are four documents two
documents per person per user and you
can see these two have the same user id
and that's the that's the van load user
you can see it it starts with a and c
and the other two nodes they have
another user id which is for pixelity av
remember this a and c user what we can
do now is actually go in here to the
authentication section and have a look
at this vendor user and you can see the
user ids a and c
and the other user actually has erd so
if we go back to firestore and look at
the two last
notes created by pixelity you can see
that their user id is erd you can see
here all right
so very well done congratulations in two
chapters we've been able to go away from
local uh crud storage to firebase huge
feed so well done
what we need to do now is i was we as we
usually do in other chapters is we're
gonna commit our work and also tag it so
i'm gonna do some reshuffling on the
screen here
and grab visual studio code here
make the size a little bit bigger kind
of ginormous but that's okay
and let's have a look at our log and we
can see the last step was step 19.
let's do a git status and there were a
lot of files modified nothing new
so i'm just going to say git add all git
commit
step 20
and push this
let's have a look at our logs we have
step 19 and step 20 now and if you look
at our tags we have up to step 19
up to and including step 19. so let's
tag this as step 20
and then push our tags
all right that's great
as is tradition again at the end of
every chapter i talk about what we have
to discuss in the chapter that follows
and um
we've talked quite a lot about now uh
allowing the user to store their own
notes in the application but
it would be a lot more fun if he allowed
the user to also share those notes with
somebody that they know about
somebody that they know like a friend or
a family member so that's what we're
gonna talk about in the next chapter
sharing notes so i'll see you there
hello and welcome to chapter 38 of this
flutter course in previous chapters
we've been talking quite a bit about how
we sync our notes with our
firestore database and how we can read
those notes back and update them
it'd be really fun also to be able to
share our notes and that's exactly what
we're going to take care of in this
chapter
in order to do that we need to use a
plugin called share plus and share plus
is a plugin plugin as i've
mentioned now so it is not a package
where a package extends the existing
capabilities of flutter into new heights
a plugin takes a completely new route
and
basically
uh goes
well beyond beyond what flutter
internally can deliver and a packet a
plug-in will need to be developed by
excuse me a developer or a set of
developers
and it needs to be written specifically
for
various platforms that that plugin wants
to support for instance ios android so a
developer has to go and write some code
for ios for android web etc etc in order
for that plugin to work on those
platforms
now here we're going to use the share
plus plugin and the share plus plugin is
developed by the flutter community so
what we're going to have a look at here
is to go into
pubdev
so i'm gonna do that right now
excuse me for my throat and in pub dev
we're gonna search for uh share plus
after you've done that you'll see that
you'll end up here and it is by a
verified developer called
fluttercommunity.dev so you can tap on
that and you can get some more
information about the developer here
and you can see that it supports android
ios linux mac os web and windows so what
more could you ask for
um so it's a free package that you can
use in your application and you can see
that all you need to do is just to let's
go to ins installing
and you see you have to say flutter pop
add share plus
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
now in our application so i'm gonna
bring our app here
and let's go ahead
excuse me again
in our terminal and i'm gonna rearrange
things a little bit here
okay
actually perhaps i could do the same
thing that we've done before so
let me increase the size of this
terminal so you see it better
so let's just do the same thing that was
mentioned in the documentation so
flutter pub ad share plus so flutter
op ad share plus
and this share plus since it's it's a
whole new
plugin that you're adding to your
application it's very important that you
basically rebuild your application
because otherwise it won't be available
all right so what you could do is to do
a clean and then rebuilds this is
cleaning is especially important
for ios because sometimes when you add a
new plug-in um since
flutter uses cocoa pods in order to
handle ios
dependencies then your build may not
actually be able to pick up on that new
dependency so it is important to do a
clean but for android it's usually not a
problem so i'm just gonna
excuse me i'm just gonna uh rebuild the
application and see if everything is
working as expected so i'm gonna stop
the application here
and i'm just gonna make sure that
flutter select device is using my
android telephone and then i'm gonna go
to main dart and just say
run run without debugging
and it's it says we have some errors so
let's see if we can fix those errors in
here
okay share plus plugin as you can as i
can see we already have the problem now
in our application so maybe that's why
you have to do a clean so let's go ahead
i'm going to go to terminal and i'm
going to say
flutter clean
okay
that's going to clean the xcode
workspace and hopefully it's going to
clean the android as well so i'm just
going to say flutter clean android
do you mean any of these did i not write
clean
i wrote clear so clean android
oh it's doing the same thing okay
so then i'm gonna do flutter
and let's just say pop get
so that's gonna rebuild all our
dependencies
so there we go now that those errors
have disappeared okay so you may have to
have flutter clean and i was trying to
get away without using that but i was
forced to eventually
so in main dart i'm just going to say
run without debugging and that's just
going to take its time and go to
scr cpy
and i'm just going to bring scr cpy to
the screen as well soon i'll just make
sure that i have wi-fi access on this
phone
because i play quite a lot with wi-fi
and hotspots on this android phone so it
could be that sometimes i don't actually
have wi-fi
okay so that seems to be running and
here is uh that android phone and i can
see that the flutter application is
trying to run great able to run this and
on that phone
so we've done that we've done the clean
and rebuild so that's great
and
the first thing that we're going to take
care of is to disallow sharing mt notes
you see if if you're on a note screen
and you haven't even for instance
written anything in your note you
shouldn't be able to share that note
with anybody because well it's just
empty text in there so let's go ahead
and we need to take care of that
scenario by having a dialogue
and we're going to create this dialogue
inside this folder
excuse me again i've been talking quite
a lot today and that's why my throat is
giving me some trouble
so let's go to lib utilities under
dialogues we're going to create this
cannot share empty node dialog okay
uh let me change the screen layout a
little bit here and
views we have there and we have
services
so let's see what we have constant
synonyms extension services
utilities and views but we don't have so
yeah we have utilities and we have
dialogue so we have to create a new one
let's just say new file and i'm going to
say cannot
share empty node dialog the dart
and you will remember from before that
we already have a
generic dialogue so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to say future
of void
so the function signature is going to
look like this as i'm showing you at the
bottom of the screen so let's say show
cannot share empty
notes dialogue it's quite a long name
and then it return it requires a build
context so build context context like
this
okay then what we're going to do in this
function is to return
our generic dialog and this is something
that i'm actually quite proud of that we
could create and we are using it so many
times now it's unbelievable so we
literally have one dialog implementation
in the entire application and we're just
reusing it and it's truly generic and
it's really good
so let's in here let's say that we
return our generic
show generic dialog
and it's going to also import that for
me it's inside utilities dialog generic
dialog so you may have to import that
yourself if your
editor doesn't allow you to auto import
so the context is already there for the
title we're just going to say sharing
for the content i'm going to say you
cannot share an
empty note okay
and it's options builder remember it's a
function that should return
um
a map and in the map we're just gonna
say it has one button that has literally
no value
so this is going to make it a
a dialogue that returns a void or a
future of void when we call it here
okay so that file is now created
now what we're going to do is to go and
add that button as you can see it says
in create update note view add an icon
button to actions of app bar so i'm
going to go to my notes as well and
create update
and let's go ahead and just add that
button and
there we go
i can see that we're using a share icon
so i'm going to decrease the size of
this of the font is is very big at the
moment
one more step i i think you can still
see the way it is i mean i can see in
the video output video it should be
visible still even though i've decreased
the size
so let me go here bring scr cpy i'm
gonna close this
safari window
let's go to create update note view and
we already have this button at the at
the top i believe
let's see do we have any buttons at the
top
no we actually don't so
in our app bar so let's go and create
something called actions in here and you
can see it's a list of widgets and in
here we're just going to say icon button
unpressed we're just going to leave it
empty and for its icon we're just going
to say const icon and
and we're going to use icons share
remove this parenthesis from there
and then put
like that okay so now now that we have
this icon icon button there if i press
on any of these existing notes then we
should be able to see a little share
button up here at the moment it doesn't
do anything because it's on press is
empty but we're going to program that
program that right now
so let's grab the current text of our
current node so let's just say that this
is equal to our text controller's text
and we're going to say if note
is not null
and
the text
um actually let's just check for null
and the text
or actually
or this text is empty then we're gonna
display our new dialogue that we just
implemented so let's just say we await
on show cannot
what's that function called the show
cannot uh
we did it inside the cannot share empty
notes so i'm just going to copy its name
and go in here and paste it
and
now i'm going to use visual studio code
to do the auto importing for me
so it needs a build context and in here
i'm just going to pass the context and
you can see it's complaining that i'm
using a weight inside an unpressed
function that isn't async so i'm just
gonna make this function async okay
otherwise what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use share
and share it is coming from share plus
and it can be auto imported okay so i'm
gonna just also import that and in here
i'm just gonna say share that text it's
really just as simple as that
so let's go in here and i'm gonna create
a new note
you can see it has no text i'm going to
press the share button and now we see
now we're seeing our beautiful little
dialogue that says you cannot share an
empty note fantastic and if i go out
that note is deleted
but then if i go to a note that does
have text for instance van dot's second
note or vandal's first note in in here
i'm going to go to van.firstnode and
then if i press the share button then
i'm going to be presented with
in this case android's default share
sheet or how you want to call it and on
ios you're going to be presented with
the default ios sharing activity so
this is pretty much it so we didn't have
to do much more than this it's literally
the call is share.share so you can see
it's so simple when you drag in a
plug-in especially a plug-in that is
from a verified developer especially
from flutter community or flutter team
or dark dev team themselves
all right perfect so that was for
sharing there's not much more to sharing
than that and we don't have to drag on
on this chapter
so let's go ahead as this tradition
we're gonna go and uh commit our work so
i'm gonna do some shuffling around here
gonna get rid of scrcpy increase the
size of the
screen
and the font so you see better
then let's go to our
terminal
and i'm gonna have a look at our git's
log the previous chapter we committed at
step 20 and we also tagged as a step 20.
let's just do step 21 in this case
so get status we have quite a lot of new
stuff so if i say get status in here you
can see a new file in here as well
so let's commit as
step 21
and push our commit
and i'm gonna go and tag it and say step
21 as well
and then we push our tags as well okay
perfect so that's it so if you say git
status right now we shouldn't have any
uncommitted files
very well done so um
what we're going to do in the next
chapter is very very exciting we're
going to delve into a block and
if you're a
flutter developer from before you'll
know what block is maybe or maybe you've
heard of it and you want to learn about
it so that next chapter is perfect for
you if you're not a flutter developer
from before you may not know what block
is and i'll explain it more however
i'll just at the end of the chapter i'm
not going to go into the details of the
next chapter but what we have to talk
about is how at the moment our ui which
is our different views are actually
working directly with our services so we
have some services that for instance can
store stuff in the um
in the firestore database and we also
have some services that are like
for our authentication the uis upon
pressing the login button we're going to
the off service and the off service is
coming back with results directly to our
ui
this is working it's fine however
there's better way of doing this and
that's through
separating the logic of our ui
from our business logic ensuring that
our ui is doing what is best what it
knows best and that's drawing things on
the screen but when it comes to handling
logic and like
making api calls and etc the ui
shouldn't really know much about that
the ui should just convey its purpose to
some sort of a layer that we're going to
create in our application with the block
library and that that layer will decide
okay upon this button being pressed i
actually have to do this business logic
so
i'm very excited actually about the next
chapter so
grab some refreshments if you want to
and i'll see you there hello and welcome
to chapter 39 of this flutter course
uh in the previous chapter at the end of
the previous chapter we talked about
that in this chapter we're going to talk
about
the block library and
this is quite a hot topic for flutter
developers like if you're
a flutter developer and you've just been
using vanilla set state
in your application you may have already
heard about
block library and qubits before if
you're not a flutter developer from
before which i actually think the
majority of you taking this course
probably have not been fluttered
involvers from before so you may have
may have not heard about block
uh before so i'm just going to
start this chapter by explaining what
the block library is and why do we need
it
you see the way that we've created our
application at the moment is that we
have direct calls from our ui code into
our different services in order to
interact with data
so
the ui is very well aware of the
business logic so for instance the
the
create or get existing nodes function
that we have when we actually go and
create a new node that is already a word
of the fact that well if you end up in
here i expect a user to be present
inside the application so a user should
be logged in and that's
a sample
an example of a ui component being aware
of the logic the business logic of our
application so they're very they should
be very separate from each other
otherwise
but they're not at the moment
so what is block block is a um is a
library that we're going to drag into
our application soon as you'll also see
is a third-party library call i believe
it is created by a company called
very good ventures
vgv
and there are various flutter developers
and software engineers that are
constantly working in order to
improve the quality of the block library
which is a dependency that will bring
into our application and using the block
library i mean internally is using
streams and streams stream controllers
and futures the stuff that's already
built into flutter but it's like going
to a next level to make things more
abstract so that our application isn't
directly dependent on its business logic
with the ui inter intermixed
so
the reason we need the block library is
just to ensure that our ui is only
taking care of the presentation
of the ui and it's leaving the rest of
the stuff to a business business logic
layer
excuse me
so that's why we need block and we're
gonna use it soon in our application
excuse me
so if that is blocked then what is
flutter block you see block in its in
its internals is a very simple library
that works with streams and stream
controllers so it allows you to for
instance pass data from here to there
and have listeners that listen to
changes that are happening in a stream
so it's only working with like very low
level stream stuff
however when you come to your ui layer
as you remember i mentioned that block
allows you then to separate your
business logic
from your ui so
it's taking care of the business logic
using streams and stream controllers and
futures but when it comes to the ui part
in order to glue this business logic
with the ui
it needs to be able to work with flutter
so
the part that works with streams and
stream controllers using dart okay and
dart asynchronous components but the
part that it wants to glue that with
your ui needs to come to the flutter
world okay
and that is that library in itself is
called flutter block so fl block is
divided into two separate libraries one
is block which takes care of the
business logic etc and the other one is
called flutter block all right
but don't worry about it i'll go through
these with you one step at a time so
you'll learn these
excuse me
so
what we're going to do in this chapter
is going to have
it literally has nothing to do with our
application we've been working with the
notes app and in this chapter we're
actually going to break our application
a little bit by just like literally
replacing
the home page of our application with a
completely new application is nothing
scary i i promise you the changes we're
going to make is is probably only going
to be limited to the main.dark file
and
what we're going to do is to create a
counter application if you if you've
worked with flutter before and you've
started thinking about maybe moving over
to
block you may have actually gone to the
block library's documentation page and
you've seen a counter application in
there where you have a plus and a minus
button and you can increase and decrease
the value that's shown on the screen so
that's like the basic counter
application
but in this example i'm going to show
you we're going to take that example to
the next level and use the block library
and i'm going to introduce all the
basics of the block library to you in
this chapter but we're gonna take it to
the next level and allow the user to
enter some value on the screen and that
value will then be able to be
added or subtracted from the current
value that the application stores so
it's kind of like a counter application
where the user can actually enter the
value that needs to be added to the
previous account or it needs to be
subtracted from the previous account so
that's the difference between our
simple counter application and what
block libraries counter application in
its documentation
introduces you to
all right so
let me bring up this caption in here and
we're going to talk a little bit about
various components of a block
and i'm fully aware that pretty much
everything i'm saying in this chapter up
to where we get to the example is
all
very much abstract in that it is
literally just theory i'm like teaching
you theory here
i personally am horrible at theory like
i didn't excel at school when it came to
theory so i'm very aware that a lot of
you may also have the same um situation
or maybe in the same boat that i am that
are not good with theory and that's okay
i'll just explain these fast and then
we'll go to the implementation so you
can put that to practice so for those of
you who are interested in the theory of
it i'm going to explain different parts
of the block library to you now
so
here the first
component of the block library is a
class called block
now block really it is a container just
imagine a class a class that you add
events to it and every event that you
add to it can produce a state so the way
block works is that it it is a class
that begins with a state so its output
is always a state for instance a state
can be logged in a state could be logged
out
states could be
error screen so just imagine different
states of the application
so that's the input sorry the output the
input to it are your events so
in your block that will develop
you will have
inputs that you for instance say log in
with this username and password
register with this username or this
email and password register oh i forgot
my password and here's my email so these
are events that you
produce and give to your block and then
in turn your block then looks at its own
internals and say oh what was this state
before what is the current event then i
will produce a new state okay so that's
the internal of the block class
now when you have a block class when
we're gonna
subclass from that block class then you
will actually need to create an instance
of that block class and you will do that
using something called a block provider
so that's as its name indicates it is a
class that creates a um
it creates a block instance for you and
then it will allow you to do something
with that
block so
i'll see if i actually can
show you block provider
uh
perhaps we could bring up
a window in here and i'm just gonna
say so block like brarry
you cannot see my screen right now but i
promise you i will show you soon so
here's the uh
main
page for the block library so i'll
increase the font size so you can see it
as well
so let's go ahead and you can see it's
sponsored by very good ventures and
stream and
medo i'm not sure i i may have butchered
this name right now i apologize for that
but then if you look at
the various
parts of block then you'll see let's see
if i can find block provider for you
here
it could be inside the documentation so
i'm going to go to get started and then
i'm going to have a look at block
package block and let's see provider if
you can find the provider in here
somehow
block
uh architecture naming convention
getting started
is there is something uh inside i have a
little bit of a problem right now
actually finding block
provider so let's search for it block
provider
and then we end up here
and
i mean this is not the best
documentation right now to be honest
with you we don't want to look for a
blog provider right here but
as you can see it says it is a flutter
widget which provides a block to its
children so this is how you would work
with a block provider so it creates the
block instance for you and then it will
allow you to return a child all right so
kind of like a builder but not really
all right
so that's block provider and as i
mentioned you can always go to the block
library.dev
website in order to get more information
about block and read its documentation
so the next component you need to know
about is
block
listener so
what is a block listener as its name
indicates a block listener simply allows
you to hook into
a um i'll actually see if we have a
block listener i can see that we have a
blog listener in this application that
we're going to develop so you're going
to learn about it soon but a block
listener as its name indicates it listen
to changes to the states of a block
that's it so you can do some side
effects so displaying a new screen for
instance or displaying an error message
those are all side effects okay so you
can do that with block listener
now let's have a look at what a block
builder is uses your block state changes
to provide you with a widget so
as we have a block provider um sorry
we talked about block provider before it
gives you uh the chance basically to
create
um
a child now inside this child you can
then provide a create a block builder
that listens for changes inside your
block then it allows you to build new
widgets based on those changes so
it's very much like a future builder or
like a stream builder i would say and
we've already used stream builder so you
should know how they work but again this
is just theory so um
i'm gonna talk more about these as we
actually build our application okay
so
after all this we also have a block
consumer and what a block consumer is
that it combine as i've actually written
here it combines block listener and
block builder so a block consumer
listens to changes that happen inside a
block and then it will allow you to do
both a side effect and it will also
allow you to create a widget to display
to the user based on those changes all
right
and again i don't want to go too much
into details in uh for a theory because
depending on how you learn new things
theory may not be your strongest point
just like it is not for me so it could
be a waste of time for you
so let's go ahead and start adding our
dependencies in our project so i'm going
to bring our
notes application to the screen
resize it a little bit so we have place
for scr cpy as well
and we have scr cpy right here as i can
see and this is our application
okay
and the application is running currently
so
then what we're going to do is going to
go ahead and say flutter pop add block
and then flutter pop add flutter block
so
let's go ahead and increase the size in
here then i'm going to go to terminal
say flutter pop add walk
so that's going to do its work
and it added one dependency i'm just
going to say flutter hub at flutter
block
all right
and this is a package so it's not really
a plugin and i don't believe it's a
plugin i think it's a package so it
could be sufficient for us just to stop
our application in here and just say
flutter
clean
that cleans the application that we're
going to say fire pub get
this could be sufficient so
that's gonna do its work
and then we're gonna go
then we're gonna go to our main dart
file and just say run run without
debugging and that's gonna just do the
greater build if you're running on
android or it's gonna use xcode build in
order to build your ios application so
and i'm just gonna let that do its thing
now so
let's just wait
okay now the build is done and i can see
the application running on the screen
without a problem so
what we need to do as the next step is
to do something dramatic and that is to
comment out our home page because we're
gonna replace our home page with another
home page which is gonna use block so it
may sound scary but it's not that scary
i promise you
so let's go into your main dart in here
select home page as it stands right
there and just comment it out
and we're going to create a new stateful
widget again and we call it home page so
stf and home page the reason this is a
stateful widget is because we need a
text editing controller as i mentioned
how we're going to do this example right
now to learn block is to create an
application that gives you a text field
that you can enter a number into we
start with the value of zero
in our block so the block holds on to a
number and then when you and then we
will create two events one an increment
event and a decrement event and
so when we then
give the increment event to our block
then we want to grab the current value
inside the text field so if we start
with zero and then i type five in this
text field and i press increment button
then i want five to be
added to the current state which is 0.
so the result will be 5. the next time i
will type 10 then press decrement so
decrement will be 10 and then it will be
5 minus 10 so we end up with minus -5
so that's the ui that we're going to
create
and for that we need this home page and
the reason it's stateful is because we
need to grab that text from our text
editing controller okay so
so
that's our new home page and if i now
press command s in here our screen is
going to be black because well this this
is a home page with no
information no scaffold nothing all
right
so and now let's talk about this
absolute beauty that we're going to call
counter state you see
as i mentioned every block has two very
important properties one is its state
and the other one is an event an event
goes in the block and state is something
that comes out the block and so the
state as its name indicates describes
the state of your block
so
if you think about it what we expect
from our block is
a simple integer okay so we could either
say our block's output is integer or we
could define a state that wraps around
that integer so that's exactly what
we're gonna do right now
so let's go ahead and say we have an
abstract
class
and we call it counter state
and then here we have a final integer
called value and then we're gonna create
an initializer here like that
and that's our counter
you could also mark this as immutable if
you want to all right so let's do that
and let me also change the screen layout
a little bit here so you see the code
better so that's like the basic state of
our block okay we're not actually gonna
use the state as it is we're gonna
create two sub states for this as you
will soon see
now
since we're going to create a text field
in the middle kind of like this screen
and the user is able then to enter
pretty much any text in this text field
let's just assume so just normal text
not even integer so the user just say
hello world and then presses the plus
button what should we do in that case
plus button plot plus thing like adding
hello world to the previous value of
five means nothing so we're gonna divide
our state into a valid state and an
invalid state and then present this to
the user in two different ways so let's
go ahead and create a class called
as i've mentioned there counter stayed
valid
so i'm going to actually grab that code
so we don't have to type it ourselves as
you'll soon see
here we have a counter state valid
extends our counter state which is this
one and we have a constant constructor
that says okay give me a value a valid
value and then i'm going to call my
super class with that value
all right so that's a valid state
now let's then create a an invalid state
so let's say class
i'm going to bring the correct caption
as well
invalid state
let's say counter state invalid number
extends counter state
in this case we want this state to
actually include some sort of um
the value that actually made our state
invalid so i'm just going to say that
value is a string and we're going to
call it invalid value here okay
and i'm going to say const and let's
just bring a create an initializer here
a few required parameters in here and
we're just uh
like this so in this case we're going to
create two required parameters one is
the invalid value that caused the error
or cause the state of our block to be
invalid and the other one is going to be
a required of the required parameter of
the previous value so
because we may actually need the
previous value uh
or something or maybe like the ui needs
to display that to the user so if this
is the output of our block the state
remember is the output maybe then the ui
actually upon me trying to plus hello
world with five he may want to use this
previous value to populate that text
field or populate the ui again and say
hello
um
this value that you entered is invalid
but the previous value was this so i'm
just going to show that okay so that's
why we need previous value and here
we're getting an error because we're not
calling super
let's call super with the previous value
okay that's our counter state invalid
number okay so we've created
our two states that uh come from counter
states immutable abstract class
okay
let's go ahead then and create our
counter event
and remember counter event is very
similar to state so first we actually
have to define an event
and let's go ahead and define that event
like this
and you can see it's an abstract class
called counter event and it just
contains a value so it just says the
string that comes from the ui can just
go directly into the counter oven that's
it
and let's make this actually immutable
as well
and what we're gonna do is to create an
event for increment
so let's go and say class increment
value
um
or increment event
extends counter event
okay
and in here we're just going to say
const create a constant
constructor for it and we just grab a
value in here so a string value and it
should just go to the super that's it
and what we need to do is just to grab
this event as well and create a
decrement event
so
let's call this decrement here
like so and again remember the event is
something that we need to trigger and
send to the block from the ui all right
so we're gonna pack these increment
event and decrement event with with the
string that the user has entered in the
ui and then send it to the block as
you'll soon see
so let's go ahead now and do the main
part of this application which is our
block and the way to do that is to
create a class if i can spell class
and say canner block extends
block and you'll see it'll now auto
import it for me because we hadn't
imported block from before
and now let's see if block is imported
somewhere here and that's the package
block block if your editor doesn't allow
you to auto import you will have to do
that by hand
excuse me
so the way to create a block is first
you define the state of that block like
what type of state does it have sorry
events first we start with the counter
event and then the counter state okay so
if you look at the definition of block
class itself you can see the two
parameters are or the two generic types
are the event and the state
so that's here we're saying our events
are of type counter event and our states
are of type counter state
so that's that then let's go ahead and
say we have a counter block
that's the constructor
and what it does is it has to call super
you see and our super actually needs the
initial states so
every block has to have an initial state
and that's when you pass your super okay
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
say we start with the value a valid
value of 0. so we say const
counter
state valid and we start with 0 just
like that
okay
so that's our
let's see what happened there
seems fine to me yeah
okay so that's the initializer in there
now what we need to do is actually grab
these events as they come remember the
ui is gonna
uh basically pass us these events so the
ui is gonna say here's an increment
event with this value here's the
decrement event with this value so we
need to catch those how do we do that
there is a function called on on the
block itself that you can use so we're
going to say on increment value
sorry increment event
and then it gives you two parameters so
if you look at the function signature of
on it actually gives you you see it
gives you the event and an emit so let's
in here just write event
emit
and in here we create a new function and
put semicolon at the end so that's how
we're gonna handle the increment value
same we're gonna do for decrement so
let's just copy that and paste it in
here and just say decrement
all right so what are we doing here now
remember the event that comes in now is
an increment event because we literally
said on increment event so
we're we're then going to get that
integer from our events so remember our
increment event actually has
is of type counter event and then it has
a value of type string so we're gonna
try to parse that as an integer okay
so we're going to say final integer is
int tri parse
and we're going to say event dot value
like that so and try parse is a function
on integer that
will try as its name indicates it's
gonna try to parse a given string and
try to make it an integer and if it
can't then that integer is gonna be null
so let's say if
uh here if integer
is not null
like that
and then we put an else in here
and in the case of an else actually so
it means that hey you gave us something
that we couldn't parse as an integer
what do we do with it all right then
we're going to use our emit
emit is a function on its own you see
it's an emitter that allows you then to
pass a state out your block so i
actually scared myself with my own
finger so you you
have you got your you got your um this
event in now you want to create a state
and pass it out that's how you do it
with emit all right so we're gonna then
say in this case
if we got uh
if actually let's do integer null if we
got null
we're going to handle the error here
sorry about that so if we got not what
we're going to do is we're going to emit
a
counter state invalid number
and we have invalid
value and a previous value
so the invalid value was this value that
was passed to us in here you see event
value
so let's just say that's the event.value
and the next parameter is the previous
value and the previous value is always
stored inside your state
so let me actually do some cleanup in
here so you see the code better
a comma here so let's see what happened
in here you see we're emitting so we're
sending a state outside our block
so we're saying given an increment event
where the integer where the value
couldn't be parsed as an integer we're
emitting a new state saying that hey
your value which was in this event is
invalid
so that's invalid value
and the previous value that we had is
stored inside our state so your block in
all your on functions you have access to
your current state before emitting a new
one all right so that's the previous
value inside state
and if we could actually grab an integer
we're going to emit a new value a new
state and we're going to say counter
state valid
okay
and we're going to say we take the
current value in our state plus it this
integer like this
right
like that so
that's for increment
and as you'd guess
decrement i'm going to remove this comma
by the way it was annoying me a little
bit and decrement it's very similar to
increments so i'm just going to copy
this code and remove this decrement one
and paste the increment one one more
time and then this time i'm just going
to change it to decrements like this all
right
and for the big decrement the only thing
you have to do is just to change this
plus to a minus and that's it
all right
wow a lot of work a lot of work so
now let's go ahead to our
home page in here
now we've basically gotten the block
down so the block should be working as
uh
as we want it to so
so let's now go into this homepage that
we created in here and create our text
editing controller
so for that i'm just going to say
late final
text editing controller and we're
calling it controller as i can see here
let's go into init state and override
also the dispose function okay
i'm gonna bring the code so you can see
it
i'm gonna bring it up so
in in its state we're gonna instantiate
our controller so this is nothing new
you've already done this before many
times
and in here we're gonna dispose of that
control
uh fantastic all right that part is done
so what we need to do now inside our
build function we're gonna basically
we have to create um
our main ui so i'm gonna bring the
caption for that as you can see we have
to use block provider and block consumer
so in the build function right now we
only have a container so let's instead
of doing a container say okay we want to
create a block and we also want to just
like make sure everything after this
return statement has access to that
block so we need the block provider so
let's say block
provider and block provider is in a
flutter block package as you can see
here and we haven't imported that yet so
let's import that right now
in the create
parameter we get a context as you'll see
i can get visual studio code to complete
this for me it says i will give you
context and you'll give me a block back
so i'll say okay i'll take the context
and i'll create a counter block here
okay
so that's the first parameter then we're
getting an error here just because we
haven't provided a child here so if i
say child in here is a text
of hello world
and press command s then we see hello
world right there okay so in here our
task then is to create a scaffold so
let's create our scaffold just we
usually like we usually do
and for our app bar
let's create an app bar in here and say
app bar
title is it const
can't see anything because the
documentation is all over the place cons
text and i'm going to say testing
all right so now we have a blog provider
that created an instance of our counter
block and then we have a scaffold with a
beautiful app bar displayed on the
screen okay
so as the caption at the bottom screen
mentions for
uh our child the child of our block
provider is a scaffold but inside the
scaffold itself we have body
and for the body then we're going to
create a block consumer so remember a
block consumer is
it is
the combination of a block listener and
a block builder
we need a block consumer here is and the
reason for that is upon every
pressing of the plus or the minus
buttons that we're going to develop soon
we want to clear the text inside of our
text field
so that's a side effect so
by us saying that okay whenever there's
a new state coming out of our block we
want to clear something so this is a
signal when you want to do a side effect
that has nothing really to do with like
a business logic or such
then that is your listener so
so we're saying that we need a block
listener but also we want to for
instance be able to
have a builder so we want to build our
ui based on the current state of the
block
well that is block builder so if you
need a block listener anywhere in your
application and a block builder you need
to instead use block consumer if you're
if you need them at the same level okay
so block consumer combines block
listener and block builder so that's why
we're using block consumer in this
block consumer it's going to say okay
what block am i operating on so i'm just
going to say you're operating on counter
block and then it says what state am i
operating on and we're going to say
counter state
let's see if they're available counter
and you can i mean i'm not making this
up this stuff is present in the
documentation if you go to block
consumer as well
let's see in here what it says it says
uh extend state state streamable so
that's the
the b here b for me means the block and
s is the state so it's not so clear
because it's working with a lot of
generics but you can read the
documentation about that okay
so let's go in here and in here let's
have a look
and it's complaining that some named
parameters aren't present as you can see
named parameter listener is required so
let's go ahead and say listener
and i'm going to get visual studio code
to help me clean this up and upon any
new events or sorry upon any new states
produced by our blog i want to clear our
text editing controller so let's just
say text controller
uh
what do we call it do we call it
controller
yeah so we're going to say controller
clear so we're going to clear the text
that is displayed inside the text field
soon okay
then we need the builder function so in
this builder function
as you'll see the
it will give you the current state and
you need to return a widget back okay
so what we're going to do in this
in this is first we're going to grab
like um
to see if there's an invalid value so
let's just say final invalid value
is and we're going to say if this state
is a counter state
invalid number
with a question mark so we're using
turner here and we're going to say get
the states uh let me bring the code up
uh invalid value
otherwise we're gonna say
empty string so
if i then in here say invalid value as
you can see it's now a string okay
and the reason behind this to be honest
with you is so that we can
basically
display
the a little error message to the user
should there be an invalid value so if i
have if i have entered some information
in the text field instead of a number
i've entered hello world and then
our block produces a counter state
invalid number we're going to display an
error to user and this error is gonna
disappear the next time actually the
user enters a valid number in the text
field okay so we're gonna use a new
widget that we haven't used before
called visibility and this visibility is
gonna be based on whether there is an
invalid state or not so
you'll soon see actually how we're gonna
implement that so
let's go and as our builder's main like
return value create a column
okay and column has to have children all
right so
what we're going to do is to first
display a text field sorry a text in
here so let's just say text
and we're going to say current value is
equal to this state value
all right so that's going to be the
current value of our
state and if i do command s you can see
that it says current value is 0.
so that's the current value then what
we're going to do is to go ahead and
create a
visibility widget which in case the
current state is counter state invalid
number is going to display an error
message to the user so let's say we're
going to control the visibility of that
error message using the visibility
widget
like this
and it's childband is going to be
a text that says
invalid inputs and then we're going to
add the invalid value in here as you can
see as we've constructed that up there
already
and the visibility flag you see we have
to return a boolean okay so how do we
know that
we have to display
this widget
with visibility and that is if you can
grab hold of your state and say okay
this state is actually counter state
invalid number so let's just say state
is counter state invalid number just
like that okay so that's how we grab
hold of that invisibility
and you can see at the moment it's not
displayed all right even if we even if
we put some
um actually let me just
say is not
and then save it and you'll see now it
says invalid input so it's just
displayed right there okay but if you
say state is then it's going to
disappear because the current state is
not invalid number
okay that was for visibility now let's
go and add our text field
so where the user can actually enter
some information in the ui so let's just
say text field
as the first parameter we're going to
say the controller
is our controller
okay
and what we're going to do is we're
going to give it a hint text so let's
say decoration is a const inputs
decoration
like that i'm going to put the code a
little bit higher on the screen
so for the hint text i'm just going to
say
enter and number here
like this okay and also let's just
enforce the keyboard type
uh text input type
of a number
all right but also remember if you
oops
the controller has not been initialized
really i thought we initialized the
controller
yeah maybe you have to do a hot restart
there we go so now we have enter a
number here okay
great stuff now all right this is what i
was going to say even though we have a
text field here and we actually said
that the keyboard should be numerical
but i can still paste non-numerical
numbers in here so if i like use the
paste functionality in android or is so
that's the reason we have that invalid
state in case someone else someone
actually enters another value except for
a number and there are also input
formatters in flutter that you can use
in order to for instance um
avoid users entering non-valid values in
your text fields but that's a whole
other subject that we're not going to
discuss in this chapter so
then what we're going to do is we're
going to have two text buttons for
increment and decrement so let's after
this text field create a row so
a row is like the opposite of a column
whereas a column displays those
components vertically one after one
after each other a row creates its
components horizontally from left to
right and left speaking languages and
right to left
right
speaking right side speaking language i
believe
i think actually row changes it's uh
it should at least change is uh
how it arranges components based on the
language but i'm not quite sure about
that
so let's say row it has children
and it's two text buttons okay
that have unpressed at the moment empty
and um
it's a child it just says cons text just
minus like this okay so that's first
that's the first button
and then for the next one i'm just gonna
copy this text button and i'm gonna
paste it right here and in here i'm just
going to say plus
all right so in here when the minus
button is tapped i want to convey this
information to our block so i want to
say grab the controllers text and make
sure that you send this increment
where is it here
increment event to the block so we kind
of need to grab hold of our block
how do we do that the way to do that is
using a convenient function that
the good people at good
very good ventures have created on
context and it's called read
and in here you can actually say i want
to read my counter block like this okay
so this gives you access to your block
that has been created by the block
provider
so let's go ahead and in here let's say
after we read that we want to add a new
event to it like this and we want to add
an increment event that has the value of
our
controller.txt
like this all right so
this is how you send events to your
block and the same thing since we're
actually sorry about that this should be
decrement so let's just say decrement
like that and we copy the same code and
we bring it to our increment function as
unpressed button here and instead of
decrement then we're going to say
increment
right
perfect okay so let's see now let's test
this application so at the moment we
have current value zero now if i press
the plus button as you can see it says
invalid input
all right but if i say 2
and press the plus button you can see
the value of 2 is entered there if i say
hello world here
i press minus and it says oh invalid
input hello world is invalid and as you
can see it clears this text and that's
because of this listener here
uh this listener because a block
consumer is also block listener remember
so it's a combination of a block
listener and a block uh
builder
so that's the clear working and the part
that is handling this invalid input is
this thing so visibility if the current
state is an invalid number then this is
becoming visible but if the current
state is not an invalid number so let's
say three four plus two
it's going to be three six then the
current state is actually not an invalid
number is uh
the current state should be
valid it should be counter state valid
so then the visibility is hiding that
error message so
so that is pretty much it i mean um
huge congratulations if you could stick
with me throughout this chapter it was
very heavy i understand it was a very
heavy and very like technical chapter
talking a lot about business logic but
believe me if you didn't understand like
most of the things i talked about you
just need to practice
i'm no genius nobody who knows how to
work with block or stuff like this is a
genius everybody has practice put it
into practice done their own
applications done this test just go and
create this counter application that i
just created try not to look at
the code that i've written or rewritten
in this just try to
remember the stuff from your memory and
after exercise and practice and practice
and practice and you will get it and you
will get the idea of what a state is
you'll get the idea of what events are
what block is and read documentations
and you'll get this eventually i promise
you that
as is tradition we're gonna now uh since
we're done with what we prom promised in
this chapter we're gonna go and commit
our code
so let me change the screen layout a
little bit and go to uh
terminal and increase the size get rid
of the crcpy
and let's have a look at our log
last
chapter we committed step 21 so let's
see git status
and there were just a few things changed
so let's add everything and just say git
commit step 22
and let's push our chase
and then i'm just going to say git
commits sorry it's
a tag to see our last tag and i can see
it was 21.
so let's tag this as step 22
and say git push tags
there we go so now step 22 is also
tagged and ready
so
what is to come this is also a tradition
we have at the end of every chapter
we'll talk about what we're what we need
to discuss in the next chapter and what
we need to discuss in the next chapter
is and we will convert our auth process
to using block so
we've now talked we've act we actually
got our auth
logic inside our application and that
was our auth service i don't know if you
remember from before
but we need to convert this auth service
to block
and uh so in that way we're actually
putting our knowledge about block into
use and combining it with what we've
already developed to make our
application better and our logic not so
spread around everywhere in the ui so
if you want grab some refreshments tea
or coffee and i'll see you in the next
chapter hello everyone and welcome to
chapter 40 of this letter course in
previous chapters we've been talking
about um
our aus process and also storing um
users notes into a firestore database
and in the previous chapter we also
talked about block so um i'm very aware
that block could be an intimidating um
topic for some developers and that
getting started with block could just
be conceived as like an extra step that
you
think you don't need
however i can assure you when you get
more into professional software
development
and which is which may not be your goal
i completely am aware of that but when
you get more and more to professional
software development you'll understand
that you need to separate
various layers of your product and that
the um the presentation layer where
you're taking care of for instance
displaying stuff on the on the screen to
the user shouldn't really have to talk
with your authentication directly um or
for instance your authentication layer
doesn't necessarily have to depend at
all on other parts of the application so
block is gonna allow you to
in a very clean and concise way to
separate the various uh layers of your
application into their own concern
layers so and the services are going to
be only concerned with services and then
your ui is going to be only concerned
with ui and so on so and so forth so
um it could be beneficial if you could
actually before starting with this
chapter to go to the previous chapter
and maybe watch it again or maybe even
practice yourself with block
um i understand i know for sure that the
block libraries website as we looked at
in the previous chapter they have quite
a lot of examples and i highly suggest
that you go through some of those
examples at least and develop and
implement those examples also yourself
to get a bet to get a better hang of
what a block actually means and how
you're supposed to use it so
if you've taken care of that and you
understand like the basics of block
then we're we're we should be good to go
for this chapter
so let me bring up the caption for what
we're actually going to do in this
chapter you see the way we have our
application at the moment is that we
have our
authentication service and our
authentication service let me just bring
that to the screen here
and let's have a quick look at it so if
i go to our
auth service you'll see that we have
quite a few
function functions in here we have
create user
and we have uh we are exposing the
current user we have login logouts and
email verification and initialize
now this is all good however we are it's
very raw the way it is in that the ui is
literally making calls to
our auth service which in case which in
turn is making calls to
a provider which is our for instance um
firebase provider author provider so if
you go in here you'll see firebase auth
provider and that is talking directly
with firebase so
in a way you could say that the ui is
talking pretty much directly with
firebase it's just going through some
functions to get to firebase but that's
what pretty much it's doing so
what we want to do in this chapter is to
try to
make sure that our authentication is
behind a layer of block meaning that all
the logic that has anything to do with
authentication is hidden behind a layer
which we're going to call off block
so that's going to be our off block so
it's like the and as you remember from
the previous chapter every block has two
parameters one is what is
what comes inside the block so what's
entered and what is the output
the input to your block are your events
so you pass for instance your ui upon
pressing a button then you
you pass an event a packaged event that
we call our auth event you're gonna pack
package that up with any parameters that
that particular event is required it is
required from you you take that event
and you give it to your auth lock then
your off block is then gonna have some
time to process you remember
we have these on function functions on
your uh off on your blocks when we
talked about the counter block we had on
increment event on the command event etc
so these are the events that come in so
we're going to package those events up
from our ui and pass them to our off
block then our off block is going to
have some time for itself to process
those events and based on those events
that it has
it has received and based on its current
state it's gonna either output the same
state or it's gonna output a new state
so
events come in and states go out and the
off block sits in the middle so event
off block and estate and these are three
components that we're going to develop
in this chapter
so
let's go ahead and
take care of our state and remember
again state as its name indicates is the
state of authentication either you're
logged in or you're logged out okay and
you could also be logged out with an
error remember so you're either logged
in or logged out
with an error so
we're going to start looking at these
off states so what we need to first do
is to create a file as the caption
indicates
under lip services auth block off state
so
let me do some reshuffling on the screen
here
maybe decrease the font size a little
bit because it's just ginormous the way
it is right now so maybe this font is a
little bit better
i'm going to put visual studio studio
code in there
to the left and then i'm gonna bring scr
cpy to the right
okay so i'm gonna close all these tabs
that i have right here how we left the
application in the previous chapter and
let's go ahead inside lib let's let's
see actually what we have in here we
have lib and we have services
and under services we already have auth
but we don't have a folder called block
at the moment we have auth provider etc
etc
so let's go in off and just create a new
file in here and say block
slash auth state state like this dot
dart
okay
so that's our off state
now if you remember from the previous
chapter when we talked about
the counter block
um
usually states are immutable and that
they're also they're like at the generic
states that every other state in your
block
inherits from
is usually an abstract immutable class
meaning that it is a class pretty much
almost with no logic at all it may have
a constant constructor but
in and on itself it does nothing so it
just is dictating that hey every state
that comes out of this off block is of
this type okay so
let's go ahead and create our off state
so maybe i should actually increase the
size of that font
so we're going to start by writing um
our
states as you can see so we're going to
code that in auth state.dart file
so i'm going to go ahead and just say
abstract class auth state okay
and let's just create a constant
constructor for it as well in case one
of our states needs to also have a
constant constructor so this is this is
a pattern that you may have already been
used to
by creating abstract classes and if you
have like sub classes that conform to
your abstract classes and those
subclasses actually want to have
constant constructors then you need to
have a constant constructor in your
abstract class as well so that those
subclasses can actually call that const
constructor in the abstract class
otherwise you won't be able to have
constant constructors for your
subclasses so for instance if i say
abstract
class blah
extends off state and if i say const
blah like this you can see it says a
constant constructor can't call a
non-constant superconstructor and that
is the reason that i usually create a
cons constructor for my
um
classes for states and for um the events
okay
okay now we have our abstract class off
state now let's go and make it immutable
and for that we need to import material
or actually it is foundation let's
import from foundation in that case and
we could just say show immutable
can we do it like that yeah that works
as well okay
so that's that we have a generic off
state so um actually i don't mean
generic in terms of like a dart generics
which i just mean an abstract class that
every other off state can conform to
okay so we have basically a
low i mean we have quite a few states so
i'm just going to start doing and doing
and creating those off states one at a
time so
while you're authenticating for instance
while you're
let's say that you are
you've just opened the application and
then we need to basically tell our
authentication um provider which is
firebase to initialize itself while it's
doing that then our auth state is in the
state of loading or initializing
whatever you want to call it but we kind
of need have to have a state that
indicates to the application that hey
something is happening with the auth
process and it is in the in the process
of loading so let's go ahead and define
that so let's just say off state loading
extends off state just like that okay
and this could also have a const
constructor so let's just say like that
okay so
that's the state of loading and we can
actually use the state of loading and i
believe we're actually going to use it
while the user for instance is has just
opened the application and the
applications is initializing
and we can also use it for instance when
you tap the login button in order to log
into the application and we're
communicating with firebase and that is
also a state of loading okay
so you will see soon now these states
are very important how the ui then
reacts to various events that are or
various states that are happening in our
off
block
so let's say that
we have the loading state let's just
define a a logged in state so when the
user has already logged into our
application then that is its own
separate state so let's go ahead and say
off state logged in
and it extends the off state
and now
this is important to see okay when
you're logged into the application what
does the application actually need from
us well the only thing the application
needs from us when you have logged in
with the user is the current user at the
moment we are going to our auth provider
and or our auth service and grabbing the
current user but if we're gonna move
over to block and like blockifying our
entire auth process then it makes more
sense for us to grab the current user
that has logged into the application
from the current state of our auth block
it's it's i mean to me it's really
beautiful because
it makes sure that we can separate
the auth service and the auth provider
from the ui by putting a block in the
middle
so
i mean the name kind of
it may sound like you're blocking the ui
but that's not how block is written as
bloc it's not block so
but that's that's what we need to do so
let's just say we have the final off
user and it's going to auto import it
for me if you're using vim if you're on
linux and or if you're using subline
that it's not able to auto import things
then you'll need to auto you need to
import off user yourself okay
so let's say that a state of logged in
or always carries with itself the
currently logged in user okay so we're
just going to say user and i'm going to
create a constant constructor then for
this class as well which in turn is
going to cause
automatically for us on off state okay
so that's our state of logged in
now let's say that we're going to define
also
a logged out state and but also we want
to um
we
actually before we go to log out maybe
we have to talk about talk about login
when you're trying to log in a user in
our application today if we go to our
login view you'll see that upon pressing
the button to log in then we're doing a
try a weight of auth service firebase
login so we're literally going towards
firebase directly and then if anything
goes wrong then we're doing like a user
not found off exception wrong password
off exception so we're handling our
exceptions in this way and the way that
we need to do this now with uh fire with
block is that we need to produce a state
you see the ui needs to only talk with
that block so it says hey block here's
an event go log in
and then it says and then a blog is
going to do some processing and then
maybe it says oh incorrect user
incorrect email
or password is wrong or whatever so that
needs to be its own state so
at the point where
an exception has occurred during login
that is a state login failure we're
going to call it login failure so the ui
is then going to react to that
particular state in order to display for
instance an error message to the user
like we are doing today so
let's go ahead and say class
off state log in
failure
and we're going to extend our off state
in here and what we're going to do is
that upon
a login failure we need to carry with
that state the actual exception that
caused the failure so let's just in here
say exception exception just like we're
doing we're carrying the user with us
when you log in we carry the exception
with us as well if you couldn't log in
okay so that's how you should think as
well so your state should carry with
them all the information the ui or the
consumer of that blog requires in order
to be able to
fulfill
its requirements
so in this case upon not being able to
log in
the ui is going to require the actual
exception that occurred so that it can
switch on it or do some if statements
and see what kind of exception it was
and display the correct correct
message to the user
so let's go ahead and then define that
and since we've expected an exception in
here i'm going to create a constant
constructor here as well
like that
oh actually we got a warning here it
says prefer declaring cons constructors
on immutable classes that's actually
beautiful yes sorry constant fantastic
okay so that's our login failure
then what we need is you remember also i
mean at the moment since we have our
counter block uh in here and the counter
application that we did in the previous
chapter i can't show you the ui of the
application but if you can recall what
we also had is if you try to log in with
a user and that user's email is not
verified when they were actually gonna
what we are what we were doing is that
we were sending the the user to the
needs verification view or something
that we call it let's say let's see very
verify email view right so we sent the
user to this view and we need to also
we need to also produce that state so
upon user pressing the login button and
if our off block realizes that hey this
user does exist but here she hasn't
verified their email address then we're
gonna produce a state telling you ui
that hey this user needs to verify their
information so
let's go ahead and implement that so
we're going to say class
auth state needs verification
extends off state okay
and then here we're just gonna grab this
as a cons constructor like this all
right
so that's that
and also after doing that so now we have
login and login failure we have needs
verification and we have the loading
state if we're in the middle of for
instance making an api call that could
take some time
the other state that we need is also
logged out if you're in the log out
state then we need to produce that so
let's just say class off state um
why is everything yellow
class
state logged out
okay
and this is going to extend offset as
well
let's then make a constant constructor
for this like this great all right
so log out when you're logged out you're
logged out there's nothing that the
logged out state actually has to carry
with itself it doesn't have to carry the
currently logged in user or anything or
even the current user in firebase even
if even if you have anonymous users the
logged out state for our application
doesn't have to carry with itself
anything okay
and last but not least we also have to
define our logout errors and so upon
logging out you could also
encounter some errors like if if
a firebase for some reason is trying to
make an api call and that api call
doesn't succeed then it is going to give
us an error so let's just define that as
well let's just say class you see we
have that already for login failure
let's go and actually copy that and
paste it here
and here instead of login i'm just going
to say log out failure and copy that
name and put it in the consonant
constructor as well
great so we have one two
three
four five and six
um
off states so that looks actually really
good
so our auth states are now defined okay
and
please save this file as well
now
we need to define the inputs you see the
states have been the output of our off
block which we're going to write soon
the off block we haven't written it yet
but these have been the outputs now what
are the inputs imagine in our off inputs
we have to think about what the ui what
the ui is actually going to call so
the ui is going to send packages of data
to this off block and these packages of
data are the events so we need to make
sure that the events
can contain with them the data that the
ui can package and send to our off block
for instance during logging in what
event is it okay it's let's just say off
event login what should it contain well
it should be the email and password
something like that okay upon log out
okay that's a log out event what should
it contain
no it's nothing it's just a log out
event it shouldn't even provide the
email and password it should log out the
currently logged in user from the
application
so we need to think about events and
their consumers and also the states and
their consumers so you have to pack
enough information both into your states
and into your events
so that the consumer of your blog can
actually both receive enough information
and be able to pack enough information
to send to your auth
let's start to your block
okay now what we need to do is just go
and define our auth event right here in
lib services auth block off state
we have written our off state so i'm
just going to close that file and let's
go in the same folder called blocking
here you see lib services auth block
we're going to create a new file called
auth event so right click new file off
event
and marked
all right and now we have our off event
and we need to do something very similar
to what we did with off state in that we
need to define
a um
a super class an abstract class that
basically
engulfs all other um auth event so every
auth event in our application is going
to be of this type so let's say
immutable and we don't have access to it
yet so let's just um
let me just write it for now let's just
abstract
class of events
and a constant constructor which you now
know
why we're creating
an immutable comes from foundation we've
already done this so import immutable
okay
uh
oh
use show
sorry i programming quite a lot of
languages python and rust and swift and
you name it javascript so it's sometimes
a little bit messy in my head about
imports
so um
there are quite a lot of different ways
of important things in different
languages so i sometimes mix them up
and so now we have our aus event
which is an immutable abstract class so
now what we need from the ui is upon it
wanting to initialize our auth you see
at the moment let's see actually what we
have in our
main dart file this is just us having a
look
and you can see here
and that's that's the counter block but
how we had it before is if you remember
in our home page we had upon the entire
home page being loaded we were saying
auth service firebase initialize so this
is a signal from the ui that needs to
now go to our auth block and say hey
initialize yourself so
let's define that signal or event
let's say auth event initialize
extends off event
[Music]
and it has no parameters it's as you saw
in main darts it's literally just a
function being called so we're going to
represent it with an event that has no
parameters but it has a constant
okay
that's that's that okay we have now our
auth event initialize
what we also need is an auth event for
logging in and as i mentioned it's very
simple it's just with an email and
password so let's just go ahead and say
off
of event login something like this
or log in with a capital i extends off
event
and we need we need two parameters to be
passed in here let's just say final
string email
and we also need a password so let's
just type that here
password and now we have the email and
password we're just going to create a
constructor here and make it constant
just like that okay
so now we have our login event
and so login event should carry with
itself every piece of information that
the auth block will need in the future
in order to log in that user into the
into our provider which in this case is
firebase okay
so after defining login we also need to
define log out now if you have a look at
our um
there are so many files in here so views
and we have notes and then we have
excuse me we have notes view if you have
a look at notes view if you have a look
at this and log out what it's doing as
you can see it's a weight of service
firebase log out so
so this is a clear event with no
parameters it's just telling the off
block then or in this case the off
service that hey you need to log out no
parameters log out the current user okay
so let's go and define that as well in
here so let's just say class
of
event log out extends off event
and it has no parameters as i mentioned
so let's create a constant constructor
for it which in turn is going to call
the constant constructor of the abstract
class called auth event
all right fantastic those were the only
events that we had to define initialize
login and log out so these are the
inputs to the block and then we had our
auth states which are the output our
outputs of our off block which we're
gonna write
uh right now actually
so we have the events and the states the
only thing that's missing is the
uh auth block itself so let's go ahead
inside this block folder create an off
block file so off block
oops block um
dart
so
now we need to actually write our auth
block and this is for me at least this
is like the most uh
this is the most fun
um
so
because we're going to put together
three pieces of uh two pieces of
information the states and the events
and now we're creating the actual login
the logic of our authentication block so
this is
very exciting so let's say class
off block like this extend block now
it's going to complain saying that well
it doesn't exist yet
so let's go ahead and import that import
that as you can see here now remember
block if you go into source code it has
two parameters there's two generic data
types in here event and state
our events are called off event and it's
going to auto import that and then we
have to say auth state
like this which also is going to be auto
imported
so
just like our off service if we go back
to our off service in here you'll see
that our auth service at the moment is
taking in as a parameter a provider so
we're going to do the exact same thing
in our auth block it's going to say
give us a provider to work with is it a
firebase provider or what is it
so
but we're not gonna directly go and say
give us a firebase provider we're gonna
say give us an auth provider remember
that we had an abstract class called
auth provider
here
which pretty much defines
the uh
the logic or defines the interface for
every auth provider whether it's a
firebase auth provider gmail auto
provider facebook whatever
that's how the interface should look
like okay so what we need to do is to
create a um
a constructor and in here what we're
going to say is to give us an auth
provider so
we expect an auth provider auto import
okay so if you're getting errors here
it's because you have an imported off
provider the way visual studio code just
imported it for me right now
and let's say that we get
that we call the provider in our
constructor and if you remember
correctly from the previous chapter we
need to also make sure that auth block
always has an initial
initial state so
that's what block as a super class
requires so let's see you see that's the
constructor
of the block libraries block class that
says it should have an initial state so
our initial initial state is going to be
in the k in the state of loading so
let's say off state loading
like that
and we create a constant
okay so and i can see right now that i'm
not using scr cpy so much so i'm just
gonna minimize or
yeah i'm just moving it to another
screen
so we don't get bothered by it and that
enables me then to increase the size of
visual studio code in width so it's a
little bit easier to read
so i'm gonna go create a constant here
and then we're gonna create our curly
brackets in order to go to the actual
initializer or the constructor of this
auth block okay
all right now your job in here inside
the auth block is to actually handle
various events and then based on those
events produce a state
what is the first event remember this
event initialize so if the user tells us
to initialize our uh
auth block what should we do well we
should go to that provider and actually
tell it to initialize okay
so let's go ahead and do that so i'm
just going to say on off event
initialize
and remember every on function you see
it takes the
the event let's see actually yeah it's
the event and then an emitter it's not
so clear from this i mean
from looking at this
it's quite generic it's i would say it's
too generic but uh
but that's that's the way it is so we
take the event that came in so in case
you need to extract some data from your
initialize
in this case initialize is an empty
class so it has no data but it when we
actually start loading for instance and
we start handling the login event we do
need the events to actually come in so
that we can extract this email and
password okay but in the case of event
initialize the event is pretty much
useless so we could literally ignore it
by just doing something like this okay
but we're gonna take it in anyways
so now that we have that event we the
second parameter in here is called emit
and emits then allows you to um
actually emit and send states from your
off block out to whoever is watching
the stage changes in your off block
which is going to be our ui okay so emit
is your way out is your communication
channel to the outside world
so let's make this function asynchronous
because we are actually
gonna call our provider and call some
asynchronous functionality on it so
let's go ahead and see if we can do that
so the first thing that we need to do in
here is to call our provider and say
initialize okay
and initialize you can see is it returns
a future of void so i'm just gonna wait
on it all right so then what we're gonna
do is to say okay after doing that we're
gonna say
final user is provider current user and
that is an optional off user if you
remember from its function signal or
from its getter signature you see
now if the auth user
is
null after doing an initialize then we
know that the state should be logged out
it means we initialize the provider but
there is no user you are logged out okay
so let's just say if user is null
then we're going to emit a new state and
we're going to say auth state logged out
like this
as a constant okay
however if there is a user so
so now we have a user we're sure that
we're not coming into this block here
that says auth user is null if there is
a user but that user is not email
verified then we're going to produce
another
state so let's say if
else if uh
user
is email verified not so it's not email
verified then we're gonna emit
um a const off state
uh needs verification
okay so that makes sense as well
otherwise we're going to say where our
state is bought state logged in and
remember the logged in state actually
needs your user okay
so
um that is actually working quite well
right now
and now it says user
that shouldn't really happen because the
user actually isn't null
so we have already checked the user so
we could put let's see what is it
actually complaining about
user value of type null can't be
assigned to a parameter of auth user in
a cons constructor try using a subtype
or removing the keyword const and
i mean i understand this part to be
honest with you and that's correct
that's a mistake that i've made in here
and that's because i said a constant
constructor is being called with a user
which is a variable so you should also
know that we can't do that all right
because user in itself is not const
hence we can't call a const constructor
on a on a state that uses a variable
user okay
great
now we've handled the initialize events
all right
what we need to do is to handle the
login event so let's go ahead after this
i'm just going to put a comment in here
and just say
initialize just to make things a little
bit separate from each other and then
log in
i'm going to bring the code up so you
see it sorry about that it was a little
bit hidden when i wrote this comment so
now you can see how it looks like
then we're going to handle login events
so remember again an event is something
that the ui is going to send us and that
event if you remember it has a username
sorry an email and a password then we're
going to unpack that email and password
provided to give it to our provider and
provide it to our provider give it to
the provider and then react to the
various results that come back from the
provider okay
so
so we're gonna say then on off event
login oops yeah login and we're going to
say event and then emit
and we're going to say this is an async
function and it goes in here all right
so okay
now this is the beauty of a blog using
emit you can let your consumers know
what you're up to
let's say someone says login what is the
first thing that we're up to yeah we are
loading we are in the state of loading
because we are going to start loading
and make api calls and that's exactly
why we have these off states in here
remember we have the auth state of
loading so let's change our state as
soon as you tell us to log in we're
going to say oh now we're loading okay
because we don't have a state that says
logging in
but we have a general state that says
loading
if you want to you could remove this
loading state
and just say
i have a class for instance auth state
logging in that's also acceptable but
then you have to have a
um
something something in
uh state for everything like even if
you're logging out you should say off
state uh logging out
uh so then you have to have a loading
state for pretty much all the states
that do something asynchronous
and that's why we haven't done that we
have a generic or a general loading
state that indicates to the outside
world that hey
you are doing something okay
don't worry about all these saved
operations that have been in this off
state file i pretty much i mean i didn't
change anything in this file okay so it
is how we left it when we finished off
stage
all right so let's in here then emit a
an auth state loading
just like that
and upon logging in what we need to do
is just to grab the email so we're just
going to say email is equal to the event
email and password is equal to the event
password okay
and then we're gonna
do a try and catch
like this
and tell our provider
so we're gonna say await provider um
i believe we have let's see what the
problem in here avoid
okay that's fine
let's then create a user so let's say
final user is equal to provider dot
we have a login function on our provider
excuse me
and here we're literally passing email
and password to that function okay and
remember login function at the provider
level it could
throw an exception but that's fine
because we have a catch in here so if we
go to the login function in our auth
provider let's see if we can find
firebase auth provider
inside the login function let's see if
we can find out here we have various
exceptions that are going to be thrown
user not found wrong password generic
auth exception so if any of those
exceptions happen we're going to come
into this catch block all right
so now that we have a user
if nothing happens if no exceptions
happen then we're going to emit and
we're going to say const or actually we
can't do a const because a user is a
variable so we're going to say auth
state
logged in
and it's just going to say give us a
user and that's the user
should any exception happen we're going
to emit a login failure and we're going
to say emit
auth state
oops
log
what's it failure login failure i can
see yeah
and in here we literally pass the
exception there
can't be assigned and then so we
probably just have to see i can i mean i
understand this exception as well it's
because exceptions in dart maybe this is
a little bit of a
side talk but exceptions in dart can be
anything i mean i posted something on
linkedin on twitter a while ago saying
that well you can even throw
an enum value as an exception and that's
why in
dart exceptions are of type object and
in this case i believe they're even
object optional object no it's actually
an object so here the error is that
you're saying that off state login
failure that needs an exception but
you're passing it an object so let's say
on exception
if an exception happens then
uh
and that's because we know that our
login function is not act let's have a
look at the login function and see if it
can throw anything other than an
exception and we see now that it has a
general catch
block which throws a generic auth
exception which in turn is an exception
so in our application right now as it is
we're not throwing anything that is not
an exception so every exception is
coming from the exception class
all right
fantastic now we have our login um
event in place and we're emitting the
correct states logged in or login
failure now we have to handle log out so
let me bring the code up and we're going
to say log out and this is very similar
to login a little bit less code so let's
just say on
again we're going to handle inputs okay
so off
event log out so if someone tells us to
log out
like this then we're gonna say okay we
take the state oh so much documentation
everywhere um
sorry the event
and then the emit and then we make this
function asynchronous like that
and the first thing that we have to do
again
since in log out we're going to call the
logout on our provider which is an
asynchronous function we need to tell
the ui about that we need to tell the ui
that upon you requesting
log out from the off block you have to
do some loading what better way of
indicating that to the output to the
outside world by actually changing our
state using emit so we're going to say
off state loading okay so that's us
indicating to the outside world that
we're doing something
all right so uh let's then do a try and
catch in here
cat on exception
catch e
like this
if an exception occurs then we're going
to say emit
off states failure we had a log out
failure and that expected an exception
so i'm just going to put the e in there
we could also put this image in try it
doesn't matter because this doesn't
really throw an exception it can never
throw an exception
but we're going to put it in try catch
because i believe just it's a little bit
cleaner it's it's like a transaction
so what we're gonna do is to say await
our provider
and log out in here all right and should
the logout actually go through then
we're going to go to the next line which
is line 40 for me maybe another line
number for you
and then in this case we're just going
to emit a const of off state
log out
fantastic all right
so
that was it really i mean it was just a
lot of talk a lot of creation of like uh
classes
but um we've now gotten there so now we
have an off block and then we have our
auth event and off state so now that we
have those i'm going to close those tabs
after you've saved them so make sure
that those files are also saved
then what we're going to do is just to
get rid of that ugly counter block that
we created in the previous chapter which
kind of is like
dirtying down our main user interface so
let's go to main dart
and let's grab this
home page the way we have here let's see
so let's go in this new home page that
we created for our counter block and
just completely remove that everything
that is related to that counter block
okay
and then let's go ahead and bring back
our normal home page like
that right fantastic uh
we have flutter block and block in there
and that is causing a little a
little bit of a problem but that's okay
too
so what we need to do now is to actually
go
and
let me bring up the next
captioning here as you can see now we
need to use block provider and block
builder and we're going to do that in
our main dart file so
i hope you haven't
jumped over the previous chapter because
i talked a lot about in the previous
chapter about block providers block
builders block listeners block consumers
and what they are how they're different
from each other and there's a lot of
information and material available
online that you can read also
about all these things online but if
you've skimmed over that chapter and
didn't understand really how things
worked what we need in here just think
of it that our main application needs to
offlock the auth block is responsible
now from this point on to handle
everything related to authentication
it is
not the ui part remember the ui part is
completely separate that's the goal of
block in its core to separate business
logic from presentation logic so your
presentation logic everything related to
the ui for instance displaying dialogues
displaying exceptions handling etc etc
etc that's all in the ui has nothing to
do with all of what but the off block is
going to be responsible for actually
initializing the authentication process
and also with with firebase and also
allowing us to log in and log out et
cetera
we need the auth block so how do we get
off block in our main application since
the entire application is dependent on
the auth block even when you're in the
main ui of the application you should
still be able to for instance log out
then we could literally say that oh
everything inside our application in the
main function is gonna be dependent on
that off block so what we're gonna do is
in our home page
let's see in here here we're right now
saying we have a home const homepage you
see actually let me command s this and
bring uh scrcpy bag back here
so now we see our notes
back so home page is fixed now
so what we are going to do in here we're
going to instead of a const homepage
we're going to replace this with an auth
provider okay
now
we could do this as you can see we have
um do we have sorry with a block
provider
i have the block extension in visual
studio code which then gives me the
ability to wrap things with various
block
components and flutter block components
and you can go to extensions and install
the block libraries
extension for visual studio code
if you're if you're using another uh
development environment if you're for
instance using sublime you may not have
that ability so
what you'll need to do is to write this
by hand so i'm gonna take advantage of
wrapping this homepage with a block
provider meaning that
my home page now let's see here
let's say this is a const as well
is a
home page before its creation is
dependent on the creation of a block
okay
so let's go in here and say the block
provider is also using our off block
which i believe now visual studio code
is going to auto import you may need to
import that by hand if you are not using
visual studio code or an or text editor
or an id that has this feature
now in the create
parameter of our block provider we
actually have to create the uh block
that we promised we're going to create
and you can see that being created here
so
and i can now see directly in here it's
creating a const provider
but we can't have that simply because
our auth block if we go back to our off
block in here i believe that our
constructor is not a
constant so if you put const in there
you can see that it's not allowing us to
do that simply because
block itself as a library as a class
here it has no constant constructor so
we can't have a constant provider so
let's remove that const from there okay
now in here we have to say it should
create offlock
and if you remember offblock
requires an auth provider so let's go in
here and say firebase
off
fire and that's going to be auto
imported as well
perfect now we have
our
block provider that's fantastic so
now what we need to do is to have a look
in here and see what else we have to
change in
our main functionality
well
what we have at the moment i mean we
have
of course we have this functionality
here to create the
auth block for us in the main function
but we're not actually really using that
in inside here we're using future
builder okay
so what we need to do is instead of
using future builder let's use our um
what we're going to do is we're going to
use block provider
i'm sorry block builder and block
builder is kind of like future builder
but it's going to use but it's going to
use our
block
which is defined here now this may seem
all very complicated to begin with and
what you need to understand is that
there is a lot of magic happening behind
the scenes in block in that when you
create a block provider in here and then
it gets a context and then it goes here
to create the block what's happening
internally in block is that that context
itself is gonna get injected with your
off block so when you create the auth
login here this context from this point
on inside the entire application is
going to be
it's going to be populated with an auth
block that you can read from okay and
i'll show you now how
so in the build function of your
homepage what you need to do in here
we're going to say
see we have this future we have the
switch
of the snapshot
and that's all fine
so
let's just then go ahead actually what
we need to do to be honest with you is
to um
we're not going to use so much of this
code so it's perhaps makes more sense
just to shift it down a little bit to
make room for our
block provider okay
so in uh sorry a block builder
so our block builder has a builder
function but we also are going to get
hold off our um
actual block in here in the block
builder as you'll soon see
when you come to your home page what the
first thing that we need to do is to
tell our os block to initialize itself
do you remember our auth block has this
um event handling for initialize so
somehow in this build function we need
to tell our author like hey
initialize yourself so how do we get
hold of that
i talked about this how do we hold off
how do we get hold of the off block in
here since we don't have access to it
here but i just mentioned that
when you create an auth provider sorry a
blog provider that blog provider is
going to inject your off block into the
context so the the auth block is hidden
somewhere in this context and the way to
read that is you just say context dot
read and then there's a you see there's
a
function in here and if you go into this
read function you see it actually comes
from a provider here
so
flutter provider provider dart okay
so in context read let's just say that
we're looking for auth walk
and what we're going to tell it to is to
tell it to initialize but if you put dot
in here you see there is no function
called initialize or anything and that's
because the way you communicate with an
auth block as we saw in um or the way
that you communicate with a block
generally is that you send it messages
using its add function so add is your
way of communicating with your block or
your blocks about various events that
you're sending okay so in this in here
we're going to say add and then we're
going to say auth
event
okay
if you're getting an error about this
auth event initialize not being in
context it's probably because you don't
have an auto import for this uh file in
here which i had so
we have now we are sending initialize
events um to our auth block
now that that is done we need to do our
block builder so in this builder
function let me go here and get help
from visual studio code to complete that
and you can see now i get a context and
a state so
so let's go ahead and handle various
states that could happen during this
period during the initialization period
okay so let's say
if the state is off state logged in so
if we are actually logged in then we're
gonna return const notes view like that
so that is this view all
right else if state is auth
state needs verification
then let's see what we were doing we
were returning this verify email view so
let's go ahead and do that here as well
now if
excuse me if the state is logged out
excuse me again
it's off
it's logged out
then let's see how we were handling that
before
um if we were logged out we were going
to the login view like like here
so if we were logged out then we should
send the user to the login view
otherwise
if it's not those states
so
what can we do let's say that in the
future you're going to add some more
states that this
block block builder right now is not
able to handle
so
um what you want is still an application
that is in working condition you
shouldn't crash or anything so
let's just in this case return a
scaffold
and make it constant
and let's in the body of our scaffold
create a circular progress indicator
just like that all right so it looks
like that also you could mark your block
builder as well to say that it
has the off block
and also it has off states you remember
block builder has these parameters in
you see
the builder and sorry the block itself
and the state that's why i've marked
them like this okay and now as you can
see state is not an uh it's not just a
normal object anymore it's an off state
before writing that state was just an
object but now i've marked it as off
state and you can see it's become an off
state here as well
great stuff now let's get rid of the
future builder that we have from before
so i'm going to remove all that code
excuse me
and now you can see we have our off
our block builder here and a block
provider up there
so that's all we have to do um now it's
great actually we're getting this issue
um and you can see it's i love these
errors i mean a lot of developers are
scared of stuff like this but it's so
important to actually read what's inside
this what is what it's telling us is
this happens because you use the build
context that does not include the
provider of your choice and that's
because of this you see
is this thing context read auth block so
so what flutter is saying that hey
you're expecting me to extract an off
block from the context but it's not
there okay why is it not there it's
simply because the main function i've
mentioned this quite a few times in the
course but i believe it's so important
that i want to mention it again the main
function does not get called during hot
reloads and i just did a hot reload by
doing command s so
there is no block inside the context
because the block is actually created by
the block provider which is inside the
main function so if i want this auth
block to be injected in the build
context then i have to do a hot restart
so
now the application is working as it
should all right
excuse me
so we've now taken care of our main dart
file removed the stuff that we have for
the counter application which we created
with auth with which we created with
block and now we've moved to using our
first two components from block which is
block provider and also block builder we
have a few unused imports so let's just
remove those
okay just to make sure that this file is
quite clean
the part is that it's done now what we
need to do is to use as you can see in
the caption we need to use our off block
in the login view and the only thing we
really need to do is upon pressing the
login button we need to send the off
event login to our auth block
that's very very simple so let's go
ahead and take care of that this is just
easy from
go to login view as the caption
indicates and where we're calling this
login functionality here
as you can see we're saying
um
we're taking the email and
password and we're just yeah calling a
login so
let's see we also have is email verified
so we're not gonna take care of that at
this point
so we're not gonna really
uh take care of email verified so in
this in this try statement here verify
email route
we will fix that soon so let's just
remove this
try everything in the try block
and what we need to do in here we need
to read our block our auth block and
then convey an event to it okay how do
we read the the a block and that is
using context dot read or what was it
called read i believe actually yeah but
remember autoblock
and three function is not available
until you import your
provider and i can see in here says
package provider src but in the
in our main file we didn't actually
import provider so we've imported our
flutter block so let's go ahead and do
that as well in here so inside login
view dart please import your flutter
block so now all of a sudden we're going
to have access to the read function okay
so in there what we what we're going to
do is just to add an event to
our
let's see if we can get access oh for
that we need probably to import block as
well so
package
excuse me block
and then
okay
let's see if then all of a sudden we're
gonna get the add functionality in here
context read oh sorry about that it's
because this is a function i need to
call the function so add and i may then
get away by removing block from here i
apologize for that we didn't really need
to import um
block library as such
okay i understand this is a little bit
jumpy that's okay though so all we're
doing is that we removed everything in
the try uh block and we're removing
we're replacing that using context read
we're reading our off block from the
build context and now we want to tell it
to
log in so you remember we had a l off
event login
so let's go ahead and do that and as you
can see it's going to auto import it for
us
so i mean here we have the email and
password fantastic
so that's that
all right so that's gonna send that
event and then we have the rest of the
exemptions now remember
i understand you may think oh
exceptions though how are we handling
them well
we are not
at the moment our exception handling is
completely broken by going towards using
auth block everything is broken
as far as exceptions go because um
you can see the way our auth block
actually throws exceptions is by
emitting them inside states so you see
it says a state login failure and then
there's an exception in it so we're not
handling those at the moment so you're
right exceptions are completely broken
for the entirety of this chapter and
that's okay because we're gonna fix them
exactly right after this chapter
so now you know what's coming in the
next chapter as well
all right that's that's for uh our
login so
i don't think we need to do more to be
honest inside our login so let's go into
our imports and just clean up the
imports as well
great stuff so that's for login um
what we also have to do now is the
caption indicates we have to go to our
notes view
um and
make sure that we can log out using our
auth block as well so let's go to notes
view here
and right now what we're doing is saying
we're awaiting on the auth service
firebase logout so we're not going to do
that anymore
so we're just going to use our off block
in order to log out
so
in here let's remove that and just say
that we're saying to where we want to
grab the auth block first okay so let's
say context and then we're gonna
read our um
autoblock
like this and if he asks visual studio
code it's gonna it wants to import um
oh yeah it wants to import auth block so
let's grab off block to bring it in
it also doesn't know where read comes
from so
um
so what we need to do now is to
import uh the block library in here so
i'm just gonna
copy that code from my notes
so importing flutter block and then
flatter block guard and here i'm
actually drilling down inside flutter
block and just seeing that i'm
interested in read context okay and read
context is as you can see in the code is
that is the function
reading here oh my god there's so much
documentation here you see
all right so that gives us the read
functionality that we can use in here so
that's the function all right after
grabbing our off block now we have to
convey the message of logging out in
here so we're going to add an event to
it and then we're going to say we add
the event of off event log out just like
that and this is a constant constructor
as well so let's just send it send it
through
and after doing that we don't really
have to do so much more so
um
and we're also not in this case we're
not actually gonna go to to the login
view so
what is gonna happen in here i'm
actually gonna remove that and we're
gonna start testing a little bit so
you'll see how things work okay
so
um i'm gonna do a hot restart in here
and see if everything's working as it
should so yeah what i'm going to do then
let's test log out okay
so in here i'm just going to say this
log out and it says
log out or cancel i'll say cancel so
that's working as it should
and i say log out and then log out and
all of a sudden we came to the login
view but hey wait a minute what happened
we removed this code this code that was
here
why is why are we going to the login
view without that code so this may look
magical but what is happening is that
since the entire application is now
using off
our auth block an auth block upon it
receiving the log out event let's go to
the off block
so you get reminded of the log out event
but what it is saying is that it first
goes to the loading state and then if it
could lock the user out and it actually
says that i'm logged out now remember in
the main function here we are actually
listening to various events that come
from our off blog and when the events
that comes in is logged out we are
showing the login view so it is the main
uh
is the home page that is doing this work
so it's
it is to me it is absolutely beautiful
because
we are like removing
uh logic from our code and one step at a
time
so inside our
login as well uh so what we need to
let's go to the login view
here
uh let's have a look in here at login
you see after login we're not telling
the application that you have to go to
a screen x or screen y
and so we can actually test this so i'm
going to say my email address here and
foo bar bath and then log in
see it comes to the main screen how did
that do that and that's again because of
the main dart you see it first said um
if it's in the state of
loading let's see are we handling
loading somewhere no we're not using
that um but if if it actually becomes uh
logged in then it says display the notes
view so that's how these screens are now
being shuffled
and displayed to the user without us
having to do
push routes or push name routes so
fantastic very well done we've taken
care of everything that we said we're
going to take care of in this chapter so
and what we usually do at the end of
every chapter is now that you're
familiar with everything you've come so
far almost 40 40 chapters in this course
so you should know that we need to tag
our work so that we don't lose them
so
let's go ahead and have a look at
if i can bring terminal up in here and
we see bit log you can see the last
commit was step 22 so let's say git
commit get status first actually
a whole new folder was added so we're
going to say git at all
and let me increase the size of the
screen as well
so we're going to say git commit and um
step 23 okay
and push these changes
and we have a look at our logs get to
step 22 and step 23 and there is nothing
to commit at this point
so let's also tag our work and we say
step 23
and get push tags okay
fantastic so if you look at our tags now
we have
21 22-23 okay
fantastic as this tradition at the end
of every chapter we talk about what
we're going to discuss in the chapter
that is coming and um
as i mentioned just briefly
as a little note while i was talking
about exception handling
we've now broken our exception handling
in that
you see when we send an ad
signal to our block our auth block um
that in itself is not gonna produce an
exception
but right now we're treating that add
function and we're putting it inside a
try block and then there's on exception
blah blah after that so none of those
exception handling uh
catches are gonna be caught
so uh we're gonna handle that and fix
that in the next chapter so grab some
refreshments and i'll see you there
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 41
of this philosophy course
in previous chapters we've been talking
quite a bit about uh block and
um i suggested that everybody who's
taking this course to have a look at
block on their own time as well and to
read the documentation because
um i understand that block could be
something intimidating for especially
for those who haven't done for us this
reactive programming before
however it allows us to create a good
separation
and between our ui and our business
logic as that's the point of using block
in a flutter application for instance
so in this chapter we're going to build
up on top of what we've already done but
we're
from this chapter onwards we're going to
spend a little bit of time to clean the
logic up i mean even though things may
be working the way they are right now
but
and there is like a saying in software
development which i
usually strongly disagree with that
people say if it's not broken don't fix
it however we've seen over and over
again that things that work don't
necessarily continue to work or things
that do work right now aren't
necessarily working to the best of their
abilities
so
in order to make things uh a little bit
better in our source code we're going to
spend a little bit of time to make the
logic more thorough and we have to
think it more through um we've gotten
started with block but we are not really
there yet so in this chapter as you can
see in the captions we're gonna handle
off block exceptions during login so
there's gonna be
um quite a bit of um
moving around between different files
and we're gonna like basically clean
things up so we have to jump around
between files and i'm going to do my
best to explain
when i move between files as well and
like what we're adding what we're
removing and
what we're modifying so i hope you can
um
you can also follow along
all right so the first thing that we're
going to do as you can see in the
caption here is to remove our off state
login failure
so what we're going to do is um first of
all i'm going to bring the code to the
to the main screen here so you see it as
well and i'm going to
perhaps not even bring up scrcpy because
i don't really think we need scr cpy
right now
so if we look at our um
auth
state
the way it is right now i don't even
know which file i opened
um if i say command p off state so let's
go to the off state dart file okay
and as you can see in here if i if i
make the size a little bit bigger
you can see that we have for instance at
the moment
um
a off state login failure and then there
is an exception in there and also we for
instance have off state logged in so it
seems like this is kind of like a
pattern that we're following so we have
off state logged in and then auth state
login failure with an exception and then
we have off state logged out and then a
log out failure
however we're going to clean this up a
little bit here and make sure that
we don't have just like except
like
too many um
off states that we have to handle in our
application okay
so what we need to do is to go into our
logged out in here and add an exception
so
the point of this is that if you for
instance um
are logged out at the moment in the
application
then there may also be an exception and
you you you probably are asking like how
can a state of logout have an exception
well
what we're going to do is that when you
try to log into the application let's
let's say you're a complete new user and
you haven't logged into the application
before okay you download the application
what you what is your state your state
is logged out
now let's say that you make up an email
and a password and then you write that
in the login screen and then you press
the login button there are no users
let's say in the system with that with
those information that you provided
then we're going to give you an
exception we're going to give you an
error saying that well you couldn't log
in
what is your state at that point well
you're still logged out okay but now
you're logged out and then the screen
also has to display some exceptions so
that's why we're going to build a build
exception right into the auth state
logged out okay
so let's go in here and just create an
optional exception in here like that and
just call it exception okay and i'm
going to get help from visual studio
code to add that parameter into the
initializer
and let me do some reshuffling on the
screen as well so you see it better and
perhaps decrease the size of the font as
well okay
so that was the first thing that we had
to do and you can see here
that i've written we don't really need
auth state loading in auth events login
so
what we're going to do is to go in
our off block so let me just save this
file and let's go to off block
and in here we have this logged out with
an exception and we're going to assume
fix that actually let's see in here
yep let's just say
logged out at the moment and let's pass
a null exception in here as well
so i'm going to go to my notes as well
to auth block to ensure that i have all
the necessary information to pass
through to you
so let's go in here and also fix that so
now we're in our off block dart file and
we fixed the error that was caused by us
adding an optional parameter
um to our off state um logged out all
right so we fixed that now
then the next step as the caption
indicates is we're going to remove the
emitting of off state loading
from auth event login so
let's go ahead and do that so we're
going to go ahead and remove this image
from there okay so we're not gonna
display any kind of like a login screen
or anything
okay so
um
as you can see in here we're now gonna
start using block listener
um i've talked about block listener
block provider block builder block
consumer before but for those of you who
are not aware of what a block listener
is a block listener as its name
indicates and it's only going to listen
to changes in the state of a block for
instance our off block and it is going
to allow you to
issue some side effects so
a side effect is for instance displaying
of a new screen or displaying a dialogue
or removing a dialogue or removing a
screen
from your navigation stack these are
side effects okay
so they don't necessarily
create a new widget
to be for instance uh to replace the
current widget that's on the screen
instead they can create something that
is on the side as its name indicates so
listener is perfect for that so the
listener property
or the listener parameter of a block
listener doesn't return a widget except
it's just a void block so it allows you
to do something with the incoming state
okay
so what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna start using
block listener in our login view for
this chapter
in order to basically handle our
exceptions because if you have a look at
our
login view right now you can see that we
have this
text button which reads login
and in there we're sending an
event of login to our auth block
but we're also handling exceptions in
this way and as we mentioned before
these exceptions are never going to
happen in this flow because
adding a new event to your
block or any block doesn't necessarily
have to throw an exception the way it
works for us if we go back to our auth
block and have a
look at our login you can see that if
there is an exception what we're going
to do and what we're doing at the moment
is like we're saying off state login
failure
and what we're what we also need to do
actually is to clean this up because
login failure shouldn't really be there
so i'm going to go to my notes as well
and make sure that that yeah that seems
to be completely removed so let's go to
our off state actually and as part of
what we did in here
logged out that we added the exception
let's go and remove this login failure
completely okay so now i'm in off state
dark file and
i removed off state
where was it um
off state login failure because as i
mentioned a login failure is now
expressed by the auth state logged out
all right so
you're either logged in or logged out
that's how i'm thinking and if you're
logged out there may be an exception
which was
therefore for instance caused during the
login process so now that we've removed
that state auth state login failure in
here we're going to replace that in our
osblog dart file we're going to replace
that by auth state
and
log out and then an exception in here
okay
so that's that
so now we're talking about uh auth
listeners so let's go ahead and try to
fix this up so in our login view
so i'm just going to go into my notes as
well
so if you have a look at our login view
right now we have a text button at the
bottom of the screen
which looks like this this is a text
button and it has an on press with an
async okay so that is the actual login
button all right and this login button
is the one then for now that is going to
take care of the exception handling
using our
block listener so as you can see in the
cache it says our login view won't be
rebuilt since the state is the same but
with an exception
so this is very important to actually
understand so let's have a look again at
our auth state in here and auth state
logged out
so
even if we put an a block listener and
wrap this button this text button here
with a block listener
and
you see once the application launches in
our off block you can see that
first we are logged out okay so when the
application launches there is no user
then the state is logged out and then
when you press the login button with
invalid credentials for instance
then the state is still going to be
logged out but with an exception
however this
button won't be able to render or do
anything with those exceptions because
from our off blocks perspective it is
the same state one within without an
exception and the other one
with an exception right
so it is the same state or it is the
same state class at least
so
we we are actually going to fix that um
but for now we're just going to go ahead
and do some cleanup in here
so let's go ahead and as the caption
indicates we're gonna handle some
exceptions in our text button in here
so let's go and wrap our text button um
with a block listener okay so i'm gonna
do command dots on this
and then i'm gonna say wrap with block
listener and as i've mentioned this
previously i have this these wrap with
block etc because i have an extension in
visual studio code call call block that
is from felix angelov i hope that i'm
pronouncing pronouncing his name right
from um very good ventures who are the
people who are basically sponsoring
block library
so
that is the reason i see all those wrap
with block etc in visual studio code if
you don't have that you may have to do
this part by hand like to create a block
listener in here but i'm just gonna take
advantage of having that extension in
visual studio code and just say wrap
with block listener okay
and here you can see it says okay what
type of a block is it and i'm gonna just
say it is the off block
and it says what state does it have then
i'm gonna say off state
all right and then here it says okay do
whatever you want to do now
so
um
that was the wrapping of our text button
with a block listener so that's that's
just that just went smoothly
now what we have to do is as you can see
in the caption is to handle three
separate exceptions that might happen
during login let's go back let's take a
trip back to our
firebase auth provider
um so firebase author provider dart file
and have a look at our login
code as you can see in here
and you can see that there could be
three exceptions that might happen that
are called firebase auth exception user
not found wrong password etc
so we need to handle these off
exceptions so user not found wrong
password and generic auth exception okay
so let's go in here and just say that
okay if state is um off
state logged out like that
so
remember inside logged out we could have
an exception an optional exception and
that's exactly what we're gonna handle
right now
so let's say if
that was you see we said now if state is
logged out so now in this code block in
here dart is going to understand that
okay anywhere in here state is
auth state logged out so you have access
to exception right here okay
so then we're going to say if states
exception is
user not found off exception
and we're gonna display a weight
show
uh
error dialog so let's make this a
listener also async and then we're gonna
say show error dialog
and which we've coded before remember
this uses the generic dialog so i'm
going to go back here to login view dart
and for the text we're just going to say
user not found okay
then we have to also handle wrong
password off exception so else if state
exception is wrong password off
exception then copy the text here and
then in here we're just going to say
wrong credentials
and remember in anything that has to do
with username and password it's quite
important that you don't tell the user
which part of their credentials actually
incorrect because if
i mean if there is a hacker who's trying
to get into the system and just using
the ui then if you tell them wrong
password they'd be like ah so i got the
email right it's just a password that's
incorrect so
try not to tell a user even if it's for
good reasons like if it even if you even
if you think well i have no hackers in
my application
it is still better just to say wrong
credentials because the user themselves
probably already know that their email
is correct or incorrect so they're first
going to check their email so if the
email is correct then they are going to
know that the password is incorrect and
as you'll see
we're going to later allow the user to
reset their password so
so just say wrong credentials in my
opinion at least so
and then else if state
exception is generic auth exception
then we're going to display a dialogue
and in here we're just going to say
authentication
error
okay
so that's that part done so now we've
handled those auth exceptions in our
login view for our text button that says
login
all right
so now that we have that what we need to
do is to remove the uh exception
handling from the button itself so at
the moment we have a huge try statement
not a huge actually we have quite a long
try catch statements here that we have
we're catching three exceptions which
are now actually being caught here with
our
block listener so let's go and not
actually do that so i want you to grab
this complex read
and where we actually pass the event of
log into our block and remove this
entire try and catch block and just do
the context read at auth event login so
your unpressed
event or sorry on your on press
parameter of your text button should
look very simple just like this email
password and then you pass that event to
your auth block
all right so now that that has happened
let's actually check this out and see if
everything works and remember this is
like the beginning of us moving towards
a better approach of handling our
authentication and
routing with blocks so things aren't
going to be smooth actually we have a
lot of problems we have to fix but this
is just like the beginning so i'm going
to bring scr cpy in here and let's just
test this so
i'm going to do a hot
restart
and
now i'm on the login screen so okay i'm
then gonna go ahead in here and like put
my email address
and then i'm gonna put some inquiry
credentials in here okay and i'm just
gonna press the login button and now you
can see that our block listener is
taking care of that so it's saying oh
you're logged out and then it's wrong
credentials okay so i'm gonna press ok
then i'm gonna just put an email address
here that doesn't exist and then press
the login button and now you can see
user not found okay and to be honest
with you if you wanna if you wanna do
what i actually said before that it's
better to
not tell the user whether it's their
user that is wrong or password you may
want to actually wrap both the state
exception of user not found and wrong
password and just display the same
message so you could do that by saying
war in here so or
that
right
so
and then you can just display the same
message and then you could just remove
this statement from there so that could
also work i'm just gonna leave it like
this but just so you know it is actually
better to do that approach which i just
showed you momentarily
all right so it seems like our block
listener is working fine in the login
view so this was just the beginning and
we have a lot to fix so we're going to
fix those things in the coming chapters
okay
now that the code seems to be working
for login view let's just go ahead and
do what we usually do and commit our
work so that we don't lose the the code
if anything happens so
i'm gonna minimize scr cpy
make visual studio code a little bit
bigger in here and
increase the size quite dramatically
let's have a look at our status
we've modified three files so let's just
say it's a git commit
and in here
let's actually let's do it at all and
then we just do a normal commenting here
that's step 24 okay
now that it's done let's just push our
changes to the remote and then let's
just also gets get status nothing to
command so everything was committed
successfully and then let's just tag as
step 24 i believe right
so that's our tag and then we push our
tags
and let's have a look at our tags to
this point 23 we have where's 24 and
there is 24 so we have everything tagged
successfully
great so um as you can see and as is
tradition we always talk about at the
end of every chapter we talk about what
we need to discuss in the chapter that's
uh to come
and um
so you can see our routing and dialog
handling isn't isn't block based at the
moment we still have quite a lot of
places in our application that we're
seeing for instance navigator of context
push name and removed until or we're
doing push names so
so we've handled some bits and pieces of
our application and we're using block
but for instance we aren't handling
stuff in the register view or the verify
email view stuff like that so
we have a lot of work to do and the next
chapter is actually going to be a heavy
one but it's going to be such a key
chapter in this entire course
that if you could just stick with me
throughout the next chapter then you're
gonna see your applications architecture
actually become more and more robust so
grab some refreshments if you want to
and i'll see you in the next chapter
hello everyone and welcome to chapter 42
of this letter course
in previous chapters we've talked quite
a bit about cleaning up our application
logic and our authentication logic we've
come a good bit forward with that and
we've
um we clean up quite a bit of stuff in
the login view and now we're using block
listener in the login view if you follow
all the chapters chronologically up to
up to that including the previous
chapter
so you should already know about block
block listener block consumer block
provider um
and block builder of course
but we have quite a bit left and i'm
actually proud to say that this chapter
and maybe the next one or two chapters
are gonna be like the
glues that bring the application to a
lot more tighter point where it will be
ready for releasing to the app store and
the play store so if you stick with me
throughout these few chapters that are
left
we are going to basically create a lot
more cleaner product that is not only
usable by the end user but it's also
but it's also architecturally sound so
you're going to be proud of actually
releasing this application or maybe even
showing this code to your friends and
colleagues so
as a caption in the case in this chapter
we're going to talk about moving to
block for routing and dialogues because
right now you know routing what we have
in our application is kind of like a
hybrid in the main dart file and i mean
we don't have to talk about uh
so like abstract concept concepts we can
actually look at our main dart files so
if you look here what we've done in the
main dart file we're actually creating a
block builder and depending on the
states that are being output by our
block we're displaying the correct view
so this in itself is quite fine so
there's nothing wrong with this but
we're also mixing this up with custom
places in our application where we're
saying for instance context of
um let's see actually with navigator off
and you can see we're doing actually
that's fine but you can see in our login
view when you press the not registered
yet register here button in order to do
the registration of the user then we're
doing a navigator of push blah blah blah
so there's quite a few bits and pieces
left still in our application that we're
either directly talking with our auth
service which we shouldn't be doing we
should be talking to the off block
or and we're talking with navigator of
something to do push name so
in this chapter we're going to clean
these things up and make make basically
our auth block and
the consumption of our off block a lot
tighter all right using block and
listeners block builders and um
we're all also going to use block
consumers i believe so
let's go ahead and do that
so
this is i mean
as the caption indicates i mean i've
already talked about this maybe i should
have displayed this caption a few
seconds ago
but we've already talked about this we
should basically tighten up how we're
working with our um
routing and our
how we work with off service
and you can see in here we need a few
more auth events in order to be able to
achieve this so let's go ahead and open
our um
i need to probably do some reshuffling
on the screen here so you see the code
better so i'll do what i usually do here
and then let's go to our off event
in here
so these are the events that we have at
the moment we have log out login and
then we have an initialize but we also
have quite a few other ui events that
the application is doing in order to for
instance interact with authentication
such as
um sending a verification email all
right so when you're in the verify email
view and the user presses send the
verification email again then that is at
the moment talking with our auth service
directly and we shouldn't be doing that
we should be asking our off blog to do
that or when you for instance um
ask the in in our verify email view so
if you go here you can see that we had
this
um log out button or the restart button
so let's go ahead and i'm going to bring
scrcpy in here and let's
actually to be able to show to verify
email we have to have a user who hasn't
been verified but if you remember from
before if you've created a user just
recently
or just just now for instance and that
user hasn't verified their credentials
then they're gonna always be moved into
this verify email view in which they
have to for instance say that yeah um i
am i did they had the ability to send a
verification email to their email again
or restart the whole process meaning to
log out and just go to the registered
login viewing and so
that is at the moment happening directly
you can see it's off service directly to
the auth service and we should be doing
that and then there is a navigator of
push name then removed until which we
shouldn't be doing either
so in order to tighten these things up
we need a few more events in our auth
event dart file and that's what we're
going to do right now
so let's go to our auth event file and
i'm gonna do the same thing in my notes
so um the first
new event that we're gonna create in
here as you can see it's called auth
event send email verification all right
so let's go ahead and do that i'm going
to get rid of this bottom view in here
and also the project structure
so i've already written that in my notes
so i'm just going to bring it here to
the to visual studio code so i don't
have to write it manually but the event
name should be called off event send
email verification the goal is for our
verify email view to send this event to
our off block in order to request a new
verification email to be sent to the
currently logged in user okay
we also need a register event so the
goal is that inside register view so
let's go have a look at the register
view right now and you can see when the
user presses the register button at the
moment we're saying uh firebase create
user so we're going directly to firebase
auth service
and we're saying create user and then
immediately we're saying send email
verification so we shouldn't be doing
any of these so these three things that
we're doing here are pretty much wrong
from the architecture perspective so we
shouldn't be talking with these services
directly we should clean this up okay
in order to achieve that we need to go
back to our auth event and create a new
oz event called register
so i'm going to bring that at the bottom
of login here so let me go ahead and
create a new
off event we call it class of event
register
and of course we're going to extend our
auth event
and for register we need two parameters
if we go back to the register view you
see upon registering we're always
sending the email and the password so
let's go ahead and do the same thing in
here so we say final string email and
i'm going to copy this and i'm going to
say just password and get help from
visual studio code to create this
constant constructor okay you may want
to make these required name fields using
these but i'm not going to do that so
i'm just going to leave it like this
with email and password okay
so that's our off event register
excuse me
so the other thing that we need
an event called should register so um
basically that means for instance if you
um haven't really registered a user yet
then we need to
send this event i'm actually gonna have
a look in my login view
and that is if you for instance go to a
login view in here
and then you have a look at this button
that we have in here not registered yet
register here that is basically the
event that we're going to implement
right now so we're going to tell the off
block that hey you should register user
okay and then off block is then going to
change its state to a state that the
application is going to understand and
automatically send the user to the
register view okay so
that's the use case
so um let's go ahead i'm gonna just
check my notes as well let's go ahead
and develop this should register and
i've already done that in my notes so
i'm gonna bring it at the bottom of off
event register but you will need to
write this yourself so it looks like
auth event should register extends off
event and it just has a constant
constructor so it's very simple okay
so that was for our auth um event should
register
so
at the moment if we go now as you can
see it in caption we need also and now
we've done the auth events like this
stuff that we had to create in order to
be able to handle various
um events that come from the ui but we
also need to fix up our states so let's
go to our off state and have a refresher
in here you can see we have the state
loading
logged in needs verification logged out
and log out failure but we're going to
clean this up a little bit and make sure
that we have every state that our
application requires in order to be able
to for instance display dialogs or do
routing okay
so
in at the moment in our off state what
we need to do is to create you see we
have this loading state and what we're
going to do is to actually remove the
loading state and we're going to create
an auth state called on initialized all
right so
um
let's go ahead and actually remove this
off states loading and create a class in
here say auth state
on initialized because when you land in
the application
for the first time you may actually want
to for instance
display some sort of loading screen or
whatever and we're going to indicate
that the application hasn't really
initialized firebase or its
authentication system using this off
state uninitialized it's just this is a
cleaner way of indicating to the two
the call side which is ui that hey we
haven't yet been initialized so you need
to call the initialize function on our
off block okay or sorry you have to send
the auth event of
uh initialize auth event okay so let's
go to off state so
just to recap i removed off state
loading
and now we're going to put in our off
state uninitialized so we're going to
say uninitialize extends off state
and let's just create a constant
constructor for it as well like that
okay
so the other thing that we have to
implement as well is to
obviously we've talked about login like
here login logged out and then log out
failure etc
and and now we actually have to start
talking about what happens when the user
presses the register button when the
user presses the register button we also
have to handle
the case that yeah we are registering at
the moment so it's a process that's
ongoing but we also have to talk about
what happens if the registration
fails so we're in the process of
registering either it goes fine and then
we say you're registered or we say
registry registration failed so let's go
ahead and create
a um a state in here right after
uninitialized let's just say class
of state
what are we calling it registering
extends off state okay and let's just in
here
as we're doing in here for instance in
the state of logged out let's just copy
this
exception and bring it into off state
registering
and then let's create a constant
constructor here for our off state
registering and i'm just going to say
constant here okay so now we have
registering like that
so now we have registering logged in
and we also actually need to remove off
state logged out failure
because we well
excuse me
we have logged out with an exception
um so let's go ahead and do that right
now let's just remove off state log
log out failure as well
all right so
excuse me again
so that's for off state registering
so
as you can see in the caption it says
loading of the logged out state we need
login screen to have a loading dialog so
we need is loading in the auth state
logged out so let's have a look at
our logged out here
and
previously we had this loading state as
a separate state so it was off state
loading and we were gonna generically
use it everywhere but now what we're
gonna do is to build this loading state
into
or to build this loading flag into
existing states themselves so
let's then go ahead and say well
when you press the login button what
we're going to do first is just to say
um actually wait let's go one step back
let's say you just landed in the
application but you already have a user
which you haven't logged them before
okay so your state is logged out and the
exception is null
and we're going to add a flag in here
and say final bool is loading
and let's add that is loading to this
parameter in here and make both of these
required parameters okay like this
and put a
comma there as well like this boom so
when you land in the application
exception your state is logged out there
is no exception so exceptions null and
is loading is false because we're not
loading anything then you write your
credentials and you press the login
button then what happens state is still
logged out exception is null but loading
is true
then let's just say that you entered the
incorrect credentials then what we're
going to do in our block auth block is
going to say ooh you're off state logged
out there is an exception and is loading
is false
and then you'd be like okay now i
entered the inquiry credentials then
you're gonna correct those and then
press the login button again now what
are we gonna say we're gonna say okay
all state logged out exception is
nothing and then is loading is true
and if then
we can log you in that we're gonna
produce another state for you so you see
this is how we're using states to convey
the
cur like the correct state of the
application to the consumer which is the
ui okay
so and this is not like you may think oh
how does he know that this is the right
right way of doing things well
there is no rights and wrong in here it
is just how you
reason about your application
and when i say there is no right and
wrong
what i mean is that some things are more
right than the others and some things
are more wrong than the others but
what you need to find is like the sweet
spot in here which is
which is exactly
good for your application and at the
same time is not incorrect okay and that
is the definition of write for your
application and in this case this is the
definition of right for this application
so you just need to find a sweet spot
for your application okay
so
now let's have a look in here a little
and talk a little about a little bit
about equality um
and
what i mean by equality in here is that
you see what i talked about is three
different logged out states logged out
with exception null is loading false
logged out with exceptional is loading
true and then logged out with an
exception and is loading false for
instance
so you're producing three different
types of states all of the same class
so how will
how will uh your application understand
that these are actually different states
so
you kind of need to differentiate
between various states of your off state
logged out so you kind of need to tell
your application that hey
although the previous state was also off
state logged out and the correct like
the one that i'm producing right now is
also off state logged out but these two
states could actually be different from
each other and in what they contain so
you need to kind of create like an
equality
and
logic into your states to tell the
application hey this
although it's the same is like a new
instance of the same state class but
internally is not the same thing and for
that we have to implement equality all
right
now there is a good package that allows
you to do this in order to implement
equality in your applications and in
your dart code and it is called
equitable so let's go ahead and import
that and don't be intimidated by all
these logs in here it's just because we
have a lot of problems that we're fixing
at the moment so let's go ahead and um
i'm gonna change the screen layout a
little bit
increase the size
and let's just go ahead and say flutter
pop add equitable
stuff like that and you can read more
about that so i'm just going to bring up
my
safari in here and let's just say
flutter
or just pop dev
and let's just say equatable
excuse me
and you can see it is actually developed
by flutter community dev in here okay so
it's a verified developer in here and
you can also actually follow flutter
community dev on twitter as well to get
some updates about their packages okay
so we're now importing that into our
application and we should now be able to
use that so i'm going to get rid of this
bottom bar
and change the screen layout again
decrease the font size
okay so in here now let's go and import
equitable so i'm gonna just import that
i've already imported that in my notes
so i'm just gonna paste that in here you
import equitable like this package
equitable slash equitable dart okay
so what we need here is we're already
extending an existing class so what you
can do is you can bring in equality in
your classes using a mix and so we're
going to say mixing e quotable
mix in just like
that sorry with okay
so now that we're doing with that mixing
now we have to implement a few
functionalities in here as you can see
visual studio code helps me it says
create one missing override okay
so i do that override in here
and it says okay now we have to override
this property and you can see in here
what you need to return is a list of
properties that have to be taken into
account when the equitable package can
basically calculate
equality in your class and in here what
we're going to say is that we have two
properties in here called exception
and we also have is loading so take
these two properties into account when
computing equality in the instances of
auth state logged out
all right
very well done so that's that's what
we've done in here so we've made our off
state logged out class equitable and the
reason again for that is that we need to
produce various
various um mutations of this off state
logged out
and those different
mutations with various exceptions and is
loading need to be distinguishable from
each other okay and that's why we're
using the equitable package in here
so um
this thing we've already talked about
and we don't need the off state logout
failure so we we've removed that already
as part of the cleanup that we were
doing earlier but if you forgot to do
that please just look at the caption at
the bottom of the screen just to make
and just make sure go you go to
offstate.file and remove your off state
logout failure and the reason behind
that since i explained before is that
now logout failure is actually built in
and baked into off state logged out
class inside an exception all right
wow
all right let's go to the next section
now
well
you see at the moment we have no loading
screens in our application so
when something happens when we're doing
an api call for instance or we're um
going to our off provider and say login
or send an email verification we have no
loading screen inside the application
so there is nothing that indicates to
the user that something is actually
happening and we're gonna go fix that up
soon so as you'll see we're going to
create a new dialog which does some
loading for the user and then using that
dialog users going to understand that
okay something is happening i just have
to wait for it okay
but the user experience that we have
right now is kind of sub-optimal in that
the user presses the login screen and
dependent on their
sorry the user presses the login button
and depending on their internet
connectivity and the speed of their
internet internet connection that
operation could take
anywhere between a few milliseconds to a
few seconds so
if you're making a user wait a few
seconds based on their internet
connection speed then you have to kind
of display to them that you're doing
something
well the the usual i mean way that you
could do that is to display some sort of
a small loading indicator for instance
on ios
natively you have a little loading
indicator that sits on on the status bar
that just moves a little bit and it's
very tiny i would dare to say it's less
than
20 pixels wide and 20 pixels in height
kind of it could even be like 17 pixels
width on height it's very little so it's
a subtle indication that something is
happening
but that's usually i mean i find that
quite annoying because when something is
loading you kind of need to
block the user from trying to press the
same button thousands of times so
if you display that little loading
indicator on the top on the status bar
then what you also have to do you have
to add some extra logic to your
application to block for instance the
current register button or the loading
button and you usually don't want to do
that but because that's just extra logic
what would make more sense is upon a
user pressing the login button or the
register button you want to display like
a blocking screen
that tells them that hey i'm doing
something okay so don't do anything else
while this screen is is visible on your
mobile display so let's go ahead and do
that
so we're going to code a loading screen
as you can see in the caption says we're
going to do it in lib utilities
dialogues loading dialog so let's go
ahead and do that
and bring up my notes as well
i'm going to close all these files just
to make sure we've also saved them
because if you close a file in visual
studio code at least which we haven't
saved before visual studio is going to
display your dialogue saying are you
sure you want to close this file without
saving it so it's usually good practice
to close your existing files before you
move into doing something new
so that you at least are sure that
you've saved those changes okay
um now let's i mean we have some errors
don't worry about that so
you should now be comfortable with
having errors in your application
because you know at the end of every
chapter we're going to tighten things up
and fix things okay so let's go to lib
utilities dialog
lib utilities
dialogues and we're going to create a
new file in here as the caption
indicates called loading dialog dart
and you see this loading dialog what we
also have to have in this loading dialog
is
to allow
to allow the caller to display this
dialog but also to allow the caller to
dismiss this dialog so it's very
important to be able to dismiss a
dialogue when the application actually
needs for that dialog to disappear so
what we're going to do first is to bring
a create a type f in here and we're
gonna call it closed dialog let me just
increase the size of that font as well
and we're gonna make sure that it's
equal to a void function in here okay so
what we're to do in here we have we're
going to create a function that displays
a loading dialog but it also returns
back a function that the caller can call
to dismiss it so it may be a little bit
of a shift in how you think about
programming if it's the first time
you're doing something like this but i
promise you it will make a lot more
sense as we develop it so let's say that
we have a function that returns a close
dialogue um and we call it show loading
dialog okay
and it has two
required parameters so let's put curly
brackets in here
and then let's just say we have
required build context
and we call it build context
or let's just call it context and then
we have a text to display so required
string text okay
excuse me
so and now you can see you get this
required build context
try changing its name and i'm going to
get help from facial studio code to
import let's say material
okay
now we have just one error saying that
you're not returning anything in here
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're actually going to define our
dialog how is this loading dialog going
to look like so it's the only thing it's
going to do is just to have a little
loading indicator a bit of spacing and
text that is going to be
using the text widget to render this
string so let's first define our
dialogue so i'm just going to say final
dialog is equal to alert dialogue
like this
and
let's just go to the next line semicolon
all right
and then we have to define the content
for it as you can see content should be
a widget so the widget we're developing
is a column because we want like a
vertical list of widgets the loading
screen a little bit of a size box
spacing and a text widget so you can
render that with column easily
and remember column what what column
wants to usually do is to grab as much
space as it needs so it could be like
the entire screen long we don't want
that what we want for the column to take
as little space as it needs to render
its content correctly so we're going to
say main access size oops
exercise it should be of type main
access size and we're going to say main
exercise of minimum all right
and its children
are going to be an array of two constant
widgets
of a circular progress indicator like
that
and then we're going to say a constant
of
size box we haven't used size boxes
before but size box is really good for
um creating spacing so
as you can see in here it's just an
empty space with a height of 10.
and then what we're going to do in here
we're just going to say display also a
text that
renders this particular text parameter
in here so like that
now we're we have a little problem here
with how this thing is rendered and you
can see they're in the same line and
that's why it kind of looks strange
let's put a comma in here and then save
the file to get the
formatting correct and let's put a comma
in here as well
like that
okay so now it's working as it should or
at least it's formatting as it should so
then what we're going to do in here
we're going to just say
we want to display that dialogue so
let's say show
oops
show a
show dialog okay
and let's go in here and the context of
this dialog and i'm going to bring it
here so you see it the context is the
context that we are providing to this
function
and a barrier or dismissable and i'm
going to show you the documentation for
very dismissible and let's see if we can
actually find that
oh
it's not helping me with that but that's
okay um
what barrier dismissable allows you to
do is to say that if the user taps
outside this dialogue either allow the
dismissal of this dialogue or don't and
we don't want the user to be able to tap
outside this dialog in order to dismiss
it because a loading screen should be
dismissed when we want it to be
dismissed not when the user wants it to
be dismissed and also
for those who are ux designers who are
watching this course he may be actually
tempted also to for instance
um provide a cancel i actually think
having a cancel button in most loading
screens is a good idea
because sometimes
for whatever reason an application may
not be able to handle for instance
different errors and exceptions that
could occur while making an api call and
i personally have been in this situation
where a dialogue was displayed to the
user and it was just never dismissed
because something went wrong the
application wasn't able to handle it so
i personally as a user had to go and
force kill the application and restart
the entire process in order to get
things working so if you want to have a
cancel button in here it's fine but um
i'm not doing that right now it's just
for the sake of simplicity so that we
can move on with this code as um as fast
as accuracy as fast and accurate as
possible
so now you know what barrier dismissible
false does
and for the builder function that's what
this um error is here we have to just
say okay we get a context
and but in here what we do is just do we
remove we we return the dialogue in here
okay so now we're saying show this
dialogue
and and then we're just going to say
the return value see we still have this
problem with the return value that we're
not returning a closed dialogue and what
this close dialogue is just going to be
is we are going to return a function
from our function so when the user then
calls that function we're going to pop
this dialog it's it's beautiful
so let's just say we return a function
an error function
upon calling which we are going to say
navigator of this context and we're just
going to say pop okay so that's how you
return a function that can be acted upon
and invoked by others
so now we save this and you can see we
don't have any errors i'm going to just
resize this a little bit make the font a
little bit smaller so you see the code
in its entirety
so
now let's talk about loading and
exception handling during the login
process so
let's go to our login view
and you see here we have already some
exception handling and we also have this
off block but we also have this text
button that is doing like manual
navigation it says push name and remove
until and we need to clean these things
up okay
so let's go inside our
login view and so
i'm going to also do it in my notes
and
let's have a look at how we've done
things you can see in here we have a
block listener at the moment that is
wrapping
itself around this text button so we're
not gonna do that we're gonna have the
text button exactly the way it is and so
meaning that we're gonna remove this
block listener from here okay
so what we could do is as the caption
indicates we're just gonna go here to
the scaffold and just say okay we have a
new block listener and remember this
should be the off block itself so i'm
gonna say off block and this should be
the off state like this so then inside
the listener what we need to do is to
bring
what we had already
um
inside
our
text button in here so we have the
exception handling okay
excuse me so as the caption indicates
we're going to do this exception
handling now inside our new block
listener on top so remove all the code
from your block listener for your text
button all the exception handling just
cut it
and bring it please up into this block
listener which is at the top level all
right and make this an async listener so
that you can await on your show or
dialogue okay so that's the first step
however we still have this empty block
listener in here so i'm gonna remove
that now so all of a sudden you see now
we have the text button in here
all right that was fantastic
so then what we need to do is to
start handling our
loading
screen basically so that is going to be
a bit of code so but don't be scared of
that we're going to handle that soon
so in order to be able to
display our loading screen we also have
to kind of like keep hold off this
um
close handle what do i mean by that
let's go back to our loading dialog you
see every time we call this function
this is going to give us a function back
so that we can close the
the dialog we have to keep hold of this
so that when the states change inside
our login view we're going to look at
that previous handle and be like oh we
have a loading screen
displayed to the user we have to first
dismiss it okay so let's go where we're
keeping hold of our email and password
in here and keep hold of a
close dialogue and it's going to auto
import that you see so if you don't have
auto import you may have to import this
file yourself
so let's say it's an optional and we
call it close
dialogue handle
okay
so we keep hold of that we haven't
assigned to it yet but we're gonna do
that soon
so let's stand in here in the state of
logged out and right here just add some
space
and what we're gonna do we're gonna say
um do we already have a closed dialog
handle so let's say close
and dialog
is
close dialog hana
and what we're going to do now is we're
going to have a look at our states and
also if we have a closed dialog handle
and we're going to display correct
behavior basically
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say if
state is loading if we're not loading at
the moment meaning that maybe we were
loading before
then our goal in here is that saying
that if we are not loading and
excuse me close dialogue is not null
and sorry
and
so
in this case what this conveys to us
saying it says that we're not loading
now but we were loading before
and that the bot part is coming from
here what we need to do in here then is
just to close that dialog so let's just
say close dialog we call that function
you see and then we say
close dialogue handle
is null
so we're just cleaning that up now okay
and then we're seeing now
if
what we have to have so what we've
handled right now is closing the dial up
but we also have the hell of showing it
all so we're now going to say if the
state is loading
and we don't have a closed dial sorry we
don't have a loading dialog yet on the
screen then we have to show it so
excuse me so let's say if state is
loading
and
close dialog
is null
then we have to show the dialogue so
let's just say close dialog handle is
equal to show loading dialog we pass the
context
let's do some formatting in here and
let's just say loading
just like that okay
and we leave the rest of this stuff in
the code exactly as it is
the next thing that we need to do now is
to
as you can see in the caption on the
screen we have to hook the register
button to our auth block when register
button is tap send the auth event should
register to the block
and what we're going to do then is go to
and find this button in here at the
bottom of the loading via sorry login
view.dart file
and upon pressing it let's just make
this and
yeah i don't think it really has to be
any asynchronous code at all so let's
just in here let's say that we
grab our off block so let's say context
read
and we are looking for off blog in our
context and then we're gonna send it an
event
and we're gonna send const auth event
should
should register just like that okay
so and i believe add event is not async
or anything it's just a void so this
function doesn't have to be async so if
you had it as async you can just safely
remove that
i'm just gonna save this file as well
all right a lot of work we've we're kind
of now
almost done with uh our login view
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna close
all these files that are on the screen
right now and we're gonna start moving
towards
also blockifying our register view so
let's go as the caption says let's go to
register view
and
having a look here
at the moment we don't have
and i can see in here in the previous
chapters we've been working with
cleaning up the login view so
blockifying the login but we didn't do
the same thing in register view and
that's fine we're going to take care of
that and i can see that by just looking
at our try and catch statements in here
you see these things shouldn't be
in the text button so
as like but one thing at a time as the
caption of the yeah as i capture the
bottom screen indicates we're going to
wrap the scaffold inside a block
listener so it's going to be very
similar to how we did it for our
login view
command dot and grab
a wrap with block listener here and i'm
just going to say
this is going to be the off
block and it's going to auto import it
for me so very important if you're
getting errors for the auth block not
being found in this context it's
probably because you haven't imported
off block so and in here we're going to
say off state
and that's going to also import it as
well and block listener is not available
in this context either because we don't
have a flutter block so that's also
going to be all too important so that's
three
so that's the three um auto imports and
they're all available i believe so
that's
auth block auth state
and flutter block so
you could actually bring it next to each
other if you want to so you know which
ones to import it's these three
wow okay um so what we need to do that
that was the first thing that we had to
handle
so
we also as i said now we have to go and
start handling
exceptions so
this is very similar to how we did and
did it in the login views so we kind of
need to get rid of these
so now what we need to do inside this
listener of our block listener we have
to handle the exceptions that we are at
the moment handling here at the bottom
so this should be very similar process
to how we were doing things in the login
view from if you remember so if we oops
if i go to our login view you can see we
have this uh
block listener and then we're doing this
kind of pattern in there so we're going
to do something very similar to that
except we're going to do it in register
view okay so
inside register view the state is
i mean all the exceptions all the
problems that could arise are going to
be inside the um registering state so
we're just gonna first make sure that
we're in that state okay so let's say
state is
off state registering
and we're gonna say if state exception
is weak password auth exception
then
let's make this listener asynchronous so
we can do an await on our show dialog
so we we say await
and show error dialog
and the text is just going to be weak
password okay
and then we're going to do another else
an else statement with another if and we
say if state exception
it's email already in use auth exception
and then here we're gonna display
another dialog then that says for
instance email is already in use okay
and um
so let's then go to another else
statement so i'm going to just copy this
i'm a little bit lazy and i'm just going
to say generic auth exception and then
we're going to say
failed to register so these are the
various exceptions that can occur
while you're registering for a user okay
and you can see in here we have three
uh exceptions we're handling weak
password email already in use and then
we also have invalid email auth
exception so maybe we could actually
handle that as well so let's just go
ahead and add another else statement in
here and just say invalid
uh invalid email auth exception so we
just say
invalid email okay
so now we've handled those four
exceptions all right
so
what we need now is to make sure as you
can see in the caption that in register
view the register button to send the
auth event called auth event register so
let's find that register button that
we're talking about here
and that is this text button you can see
it says register okay
so what we need to do is perhaps to
clean this code up at the moment there's
just so much information in here that we
don't really have to do so go to your
register button please in the register
view and just pretty much just nuke this
entire try and all these cad statements
the way they are
so now we have a clean slate so now we
have just email and password and let's
grab the auth block in here and ask the
auth block to do the registration okay
so i'm just going to say context
and let's just say we grab the
off block in here
okay
as a function
context if i can spell
and then i'm just going to say add in
auth
events of register
here
with email and password just like that
okay
so your code should kind of look like
this and put a comma in here to make it
a little bit cleaner so just like that
all right
okay that was for register
now we have also a
login button in here which right now
inside our register view do you remember
if you end up in the registry view and
incorrectly so you just tap on some
button and enter them in the registry
and be like oh i'm in the wrong place i
want to log in actually instance so we
have this already registered login here
button and at the moment that's doing
custom navigator or push name and remove
until and it shouldn't be doing that so
let's go ahead and fix that up so let's
go in here and remove that code and just
say context read auth block
and we're going to basically add an
event in here of con of type const auth
event
log out just like that okay so that then
is going to send the user to the login
screen all right
all right let's move now to the next
point as you can see it says send
verification button and verify email
view dart
it should send an auth event and when
you press it it should send the auth
event send the email verification to the
blog so i'm going to go into my notes as
well as well
and just find that button and now let's
go in our code in here
let's go to verify email view
and have a look at that button that
we're talking about which is right here
and at the moment as you can see it's
doing all service firebase and email
verification but we shouldn't be doing
that
um we should ask our block to do that so
let's just go ahead
and
first of all remove that code inside the
buttons unpressed and then this button
doesn't have to be async anymore
and what we're going to say is just
going to say context and read
and but we don't have read remember
because we don't have we haven't
imported auth
we haven't imported block or flutter
block into this file yet but we're going
to fix that soon so first of all just
say read the off block and that's going
to also import off block for us so
that's the first part and now you have
this error let's get visual studio code
to import
the same provider but i actually want
flutter block so
let's go ahead and import that ourselves
so let's say package flutter block and
flutter block dart
now it's fine alright so let's in here
and then add an event we say const off
event
send email verification just like that
all right so
it's done now
so the next thing we have to do is you
can see inside this restart button at
the bottom of the screen at the moment
it's doing quite a lot of work
it is basically first logging out from
our auth service and then it's doing
navigation so this button is like all
over the place it's taking care of
authentication it's taking care of i
mean i'm actually very i'm laughing here
because i'm kind of laughing at the
progress that we've made so far and that
we've
gone from very very raw programming to
now very elegant
handling of exceptions alien handling of
routing etc so it is actually really fun
to be here to be honest with you
so in here let's remove that code and
kind of grab this thing that we have up
here in our send email verification
button and bring it down here instead of
sending the off event send email
verification we're gonna send alt event
log out
like this
excuse me all right so that part is done
so
what we need now let's go in now let's
close this file and go to our off block
so we have quite a bit of work now to do
in our off block as you can see it's
just all over the place so
i want to do the same thing in my notes
as well so off block
the first thing that we need to do is
make sure that we are not using this off
state loading because we don't have that
anymore what we have is off states on in
each light so please take care of that
as a first name
so
we also have now an auth event send
email verification and we haven't
handled that yet so let's go on top of
this initialize i'm just gonna send say
send email verification okay and let's
create a new on to handle auth events
and email verification because we
haven't handled that so we have event
animation here and
let's just go and say this is an async
function and then open it and then a
semicolon at the end to get the format
uh formatting working
the only thing we have to do in the auth
event send email verification to
actually call and tell the provider that
hey um we're gonna basically send an
email verification all right so let's
just let's just say a wait provider
and email verification and then what
we're gonna do we're gonna emit the
exact same um state
so by coming into by sending this event
we are just going to do some work and
emit the exact same state that you're in
so we're not actually changing the state
of the application because remember when
you're in the verify email view and then
you press the button to actually send a
new verification email what happens on
the screen nothing we're not like doing
anything it's just we're sending the
email verification that's all so we're
not sending you to a new screen or
anything like that so that's why we're
emitting the exact same state as we had
before
all right now we have to actually handle
a
our auth event register
so let's go ahead and do that so that is
completely new so let's just say on
off event register
and we say we have the events and the
emails and an asynchronous function just
like that all right
so
when we have the auth event register if
you remember from before this authentic
include the email and password in itself
excuse me
so we can grab those and that
information right now just say email is
advanced.email and let's just say final
password
is events.password oops
all right so then we're going to put
this into a try and catch block so we're
going to say try on exception
catch e
when an exception happens we're just
going to emit our
off state registering
with that e um
so
we talked about this before but just to
refresh when you're during the process
of register we actually can emit a new
state in here just called registering
and then it can it can contain an
exception all right so that's what we're
emitting in here saying that you're in
the process of registering but something
bad happened which is an exception all
right
so in here then let's just say await
provider and we're going to create a new
user with the email and password they
just fit right in so that's really great
and then if you remember from the
registration process that we had before
so um
in our register view during registration
here
upon doing a registration we didn't just
register the user with the provider but
we also send an email verification just
to make sure that the user doesn't have
to go and send an email verification and
manually so we're going to do the same
thing in our off block okay
so let's also wait on the provider
and we say send email verification just
like that all right
um and then after doing that since you
registered a new user well what is the
states if you remember from our
off states
off state
we have this needs verification we know
that when we register and use a new user
that user is always going to need
verification right so let's go in here
and just emits that state so
uh auth state needs verification just
like that and that's an empty state so
it doesn't have any parameters and such
all right
all right um
then we have to handle our auth event
initialize so let's have a look in here
and see how the code look looks like so
in here what we need to do at the moment
we have logged out but you can see we're
not providing that is a loading
parameter and we're not providing
exceptions so i'm just actually going to
click clean this and write it by hand
manually
so in the emit let's just emit a const
off
state
uh
logged out
all right
so
when you initialize the application from
the beginning when the application
actually runs we're just gonna say by
default you're logged out all right
so let's go ahead and do that if the
user is null of course
so in the exception we don't have any
exceptions and we're not loading
anything as such so that's like the
default state so that's it comma in
there and a comma here just to get the
formatting working
all right so
that seems to be fine but
we also have the initialize in here
sounds good logged out
it's email verified and that so
yeah that looks that looks fine to me
okay now let's have a look at logging in
as you can see we have to take care of
our login and logic a little bit and
make sure that we're loading so when you
say i want to log in we're going to say
okay you want to log in that means
you're logged out but you're logged out
and there's a loading screen okay that's
why we created that loading dialog which
we're going to put into you so
so upon the user asking to log in let's
just say okay we're going to emit our
const off
state
log out
and there is no exception and the
loading flag is actually true
so like that and right there and just
like okay
so
that's the loading part
and let's have a look at how we're doing
things in here so we have our login
um
and we also as you can see in here so
that that was that part we've taken care
of and now what we have to do is to
disable disable the loading screen if
email is not verified so
um at the moment we have this user in
here you can see final user okay and
then we're just saying
state now is all of a sudden
logged in but that is not complete
because we're not checking whether the
users
verified their email address or not so
let's go ahead
and say as the caption indicates if
email not verified then disable the
loading screen by sending a new logged
out okay before sending the needs
verification so let's take care of that
so we say if um user is email verified
not
and we emit
a constant of auth state logged out
like that
and we say well no exception and we're
not loading all right
so that disables essentially the loading
screen okay by saying it's loading false
remember here we sent is loading true
now we're sending is loading false
and then right after
when the email is not verified we
actually say
then emit a const of off
state needs verification just like that
all right
otherwise if the user's email is
verified then we're gonna say we're
gonna first disable
let me bring up the correct caption so
we have to do the exact same thing in
here we're gonna disable basically the
loading screen
like that
and then we're going to send
this login
states right here
okay
all right and also in our exception
handling we we don't use this uh um yet
we're gonna use off state logged out but
we're gonna clean this up so inside emit
we're gonna say auth state logged out
and then there is an exception and we
are not loading
okay so
please place that inside the exception
handling of your
um
auth event login
okay
a lot of code a lot of code
um
now as you can see the caption that says
fix fix up auth state logged out
we have to emit the auth state logged
out and fix up exception handler as well
so
let's find out our auth event logged out
and we have a lot of errors in here
right now as you can see
so it would actually be better
if we kind of like
nuked this code in here and wrote it
from scratch so i'm just going to say
try
and then we'll say on exception
catch e
so that's it
and then when there's an exception
during logged out logging out what we're
going to just say we're going to say
well you are logged out but an exception
happened all right so let's just say um
we immediate
hans
no actually off
state logged out
there is an exception and we're not
loading okay so that's what you need to
also place inside your
code so that's for the emit
now for trying
what do we actually have to do we have
to tell our provider
to log out oops
not login log out
all right
and then we also have to emit the new
states that we're going to say you're
logged out and then there is no
exception so i'm just going to grab this
code from there and place it in here and
say there is no exception like that
okay
and it says well this can now be a cons
so i'm gonna make it a const just like
that
so
the next thing that we have to do is to
clean up our routing because you see the
more and more we're blockifying the
entire process inside our application
the less we need different different
screens to actually do routing manually
because routing is going to be handled
by our block listeners and things like
that okay
so let's go ahead and as the caption
indicates in our routes dart file we're
gonna remove all routes except for
create or update node route so let's
open routes
actually before we do that i'm going to
close all the files in here just to make
sure everything's saved then go to route
start
and remove everything except for
that last route
all right
excuse me let's now go now that we've
done that we have to go to our main dart
file
excuse me again
and we're gonna clean up our routing in
here as you can see we have those four
routes now that we've removed let's just
remove them from main dark file as well
and save your file please
so what we need also is as the caption
captioning case we should show the
register view if auth state is
registering okay
so in main dart show register view if
off state is registering so i'm gonna
bring up my notes as well in here
so let's go ahead and see what we have
we have auth state logged out what we
have what we also have to have in here
we have to create another else statement
and say if state is off
of state registering
and open your curly brackets um
on curly bracket missing and in here we
just say return cons register view okay
just like that
all right that was a lot of work that
we've done and now if you then look at
your files in here you shouldn't you
basically shouldn't have any errors okay
so before testing this all because there
were just so much stuff that we've done
and we've also changed our main function
it just makes sense to do a hot restart
okay
so i did a hot restart let me just
resize my visual studio code so we see
our trusty
scrcpy in here
so
now this is the login view uh if you
look at our login view dart file uh if
you have a look at what we did when the
login button is tapped we're literally
telling
our
auth block to do this thing in here log
in all right so we're sending a new
event to it so if something happens to
that and things don't work as well then
it says user not found wrong credentials
authentication error then we should
probably
actually get an error displayed on the
screen so let's test this and you can
see it says authentication error so
that's in here okay so that's that seems
to be working very well
and it would be really good if you could
actually test this um
our loading dialogue and see if it works
so i'm gonna write
foobar bads in here and say login
we saw that loading so that was our
loading dialog that was this logic right
here so it's it's really cool actually
how it's working let's go in here and
say log out and log out and then we come
to the login screen so this is all
working so well
and you could and if you want to see
your loading screen a little bit more
and like if you're in the process of
debugging it you could always go to your
um
office block in here
and inside when you're asked to log in
you could actually a wait so you could
just do like this
a weight future delayed and you could
say duration and you could say seconds
three something like this okay
so this is gonna await like it's just
gonna wait three seconds before it
continues so let me just save that and
enter some information in here say
google okay it's our gmail
and then say
login
oops that didn't work so well
i don't know why that didn't work so
well even though this is an async
function could this need hot restarting
maybe
let me do
log out in here and enter foo barba
sorry
avant np gmail.com foo barbas and then
login there we go now it's waiting more
than three seconds kind of then it goes
to the application so i would say that
is working very well so we can now
remove this weight in here okay
and maybe do a hot restart as well
wow
that that was a lot of work we did but
that's what you do with software
development sometimes you break things
to make them better you have to break
sometimes the code that you have in
order to build up something better we
didn't really break things but we
what we kind of did
we basically removed a lot of old old
code in order to make it and work better
with block and
i'm in this course my goal is to make
you a software developer using flutter
i'm not just going to show you the right
thing to do from the beginning we're
going to gradually make things better a
software developer also is not going to
be depending on their experience they're
not going to do the exact right thing
from point one or point zero
they're they're gonna make experiments
they're gonna google a lot of things
look at stack overflow find the right
way to do things get inspiration maybe
from like another product that's kind of
doing something similar and develop
things one step at a time make it better
so that's the reason we're in chapter 40
something right now and
we've just gotten to this point
otherwise we would have done this from
chapter zero for chapter one so
thank you for sticking uh
through us sticking around throughout
this chapter and coming to this point
that we are right now so as this
tradition we're gonna now commit our
code and tag it so let me do some
reshuffling of the screen go to terminal
in here
minimize scr cpy
make the screen bigger
and like that and i'm gonna shuffle the
screen as well so you see things better
so let's go ahead and have a look at our
git status ginormous amount of things
we've done everything is modified and
there's a new file added so let's say
git add all
and let's get commit
as step 25
because if you have a look at our logs
the previous chapter was step 24 so now
we're at step 25.
so let's then push our changes now that
we've committed
and then we're going to say git tag
and we're going to say step
25 as well so and then we're going to
push our tags as well
if you look at our tags now we have step
24 and then somewhere in here we should
have step 25 as well as you can see here
great so
congratulations for getting through this
chapter was one of the jumpiest chapters
i would say in this entire course and
that we moved so much from file to file
so if you made it through then
congratulations
um
so what we need to work on in the next
chapter is our broken loading screen i
know it's a little bit of an anti-climax
in that we just work on our loading
screen so we should be kind of proud
however there is a problem with this
loading screen and that is because we're
using
navigator of context and then we're
popping remember popping inside
executing pop invoking the pop function
on your navigator and actually i can
show you the code
without going into too much details so
let's have a look at our uh loading
dialogue
see at the bottom of this loading
dialogue we're doing navigator off pop
this doesn't necessarily pop this dialog
it pops the current view on the
navigator so even if our dialog is not
displayed on the screen saying navigator
of is gonna confuse the navigation stack
in flutter so we're gonna have a look at
that and fixing that actually in the
next chapter so grab some tea coffee
chocolate whatever you want to and i'll
see you in the next chapter hello and
welcome to chapter 43 of this flutter
course
we are now very very close to actually
being able to release our application to
the app store there are just a few
things left sorry app store and play
store and we have a few things left um
to do before we can actually do that and
um one of the most important things we
need to take care of are loading screens
in our application and
if you remember from what we've done so
far we've been working with block we've
been working with our auth service and
we've created an auth block
and we also have loading state in some
of our off states
actually i can't call it loading state
we have loading property on some of our
off states so when our off block returns
a state depending on which state it is
then we can actually see whether it has
it is loading property or not
and we've been working with loading
dialogue so far and there are just
simple dialogues that we're displaying
on the screen with a column with a
circular progress indicator and we also
have
a size box just to separate the loading
indicator from a text that we're
displaying on the screen
this has been working okay so far but as
i mentioned in at the end of the
previous chapter we have a bit of a
problem in that
if you remember from the code actually i
can bring it on the screen so you can
have a look here let's go to our loading
dialog
loading dialog at the end of this if you
remember we return a function
and which in turn upon calling which we
pop our navigation navigator
however as you can see there is no
transaction in here meaning that the
navigator can't necessarily know that
what it is popping at the moment is in
fact our loading dialogue
and this problem is actually quite big
in that you could for instance have a
loading dialog on the screen and then
while that loading dialog is being
displayed you could display another
screen and push that screen in your
navigation stack and then if you then
try to dismiss your loading dialogue
what you will dismiss in fact is the
second screen that you displayed in the
stack so
this process is not transaction based in
that you're playing literally with the
navigate in navigation stack in flutter
and that's not such a wise thing to do
so what we want to do in this chapter is
to clean up our loading screens in the
application and make sure that they are
using overlays instead of
normal dialogs
so now i named overlays and it is a good
time then to explain what overlays are
and why they're good especially for
loading screens um as you know
normal screens that you display on on
the
mobile telephone for instance or on the
web or
on a desktop with flutter there it
basically placed inside a navigation
stack so the navigation stack is there
to keep track of which screen is
displayed and then which screens you can
remove from that stack
and so they have a hierarchy however if
you want to display something on top of
the navigation stack independent of the
navigation stack and the various changes
that could happen to the navigation
stack you could use and you probably
actually should use overlays either
directly or using other material
components that are provided by flutter
that in turn use overlays so
overlays as their name indicates they
have they have the ability to place
themselves over other content that is
currently displayed on the screen so
there and that makes them the perfect
candidate for loading screens for
instance because loading screens are
usually displayed on top of the current
content that the user is looking at so
in this chapter we're going to focus on
using overlays to improve the state of
our loading screens in the application
so
um
now before we actually get started
writing the uh our loading screen
um what we need to talk about is a
controller uh as its name indicates a
controller is an object usually that you
can pass from
a
a function to another
and using this controller usually an
object that receives that controller is
able to control either the contents or
the behavior of the object that
is being displayed on the screen for
instance
so imagine a scenario where you have a
loading screen
already appearing on the mobile device
and you're telling the user wait while
i'm logging you in now imagine that you
want to kick off another process while
that is ongoing and you want to display
a loading screen again to the user while
the previous loading screen is already
displayed on the screen
so
a typical way of doing that would be for
instance to dismiss the first loading
screen
show a new loading screen with the new
content and when you get rid of the
second loading screen then you can
display the first loading screen again
as that process is ongoing however this
is quite a bit of a
it is quite a bit of a race in that you
have to know the previous context what
loading screen was displayed before what
loading screen you're displaying now
if there was a
loading screen before you have to
display it again so it's not so scalable
in that you will personally then be
responsible for keeping track of the
state of your loading screen so what
we're going to do in this chapter is to
create a loading screen that is a that
is able to be controlled and its text
and contents is going to be controlled
using a controller object
so
upon creating that loading screen we're
then gonna get a loading screen
controller
and this loading controller is gonna
allow us to one dismiss the current
loading screen that is displayed on the
screen if any and then secondly it's
going to allow us to update the contents
of the loading screen
so without further ado we could actually
start by having a look at creating this
loading controller and or loading screen
controller and then we're going to use
this loading screen controller where we
create our loading screen so as usual
i'm going to do some reshuffling on the
screen so
let me make the code bigger here and
then the font a little smaller
and let's then actually here i i'm
pretty sure that we don't need scr cpy
because um
we're not gonna have a look at how that
loading screen looks which looks like
right now we're gonna write quite a bit
of code and then we're gonna put it into
you so
i'm gonna make visual studio code full
screen in here
and i'm going to get rid of this bottom
bar here
okay so as the caption indicates what
we're going to do now is to go ahead and
create our loading screen controller
under lib helpers
loading loading screen controller and
let's go in here and have a look at lib
and we can see we have lib utility
service access you know constant views
but we don't have helpers so i'm gonna
right click on live and just say new
file and then i'm going to say helpers
and so that you can also see it here
helpers
and loading and then loading screen
controller
so that's going to create the
intermediate
folders for us as well so you can see
now we're under lip helpers loading
loading screen controller okay
so what we need here as i mentioned
before is the ability for us to be able
to control two things to close the
loading screen and also update its
contents so let's go ahead and define
these type def so let's just say type f
and we're going to call it close loading
screen and this is just a
boolean
function
that indicates whether the loading
screen could actually be closed or not
okay so it's just a function definition
for now there is no implementation of
that function yet
so let's also go and create a type f
and we're going to say update
loading screen
and this is a void function and actually
a bool function which will also indicate
whether the text could be updated and we
just say text so what we're saying in
here we will have two functions that
will conform to this
interface basically soon as you'll soon
see okay
excuse me
let's then go ahead and create a class
and we call it loading screen
indicator or sorry controller
and let's mark this as immutable as well
and for this we need material so
um actually foundation would do as well
so let's just go in foundation and in
here i'm actually going to say show
immutable just like that so we just need
the immutable part of the foundation
um package in here
okay so that's the definition of our
loading screen controller so what it
does is that it basically it takes in a
closed loading screen as a parameter and
we say
um close
and we also say final update loading
screen
updates just like that and i'm going to
get help from visual studio code to
complete this as a constant constructor
and i'm going to make these parameters
also required so these things we've
talked about so much before so that's
why i'm kind of jumping over them as
fast as possible hot reload is not
working so well right now it's just
because the application on scrcpy is not
on the screen and that's why hot reload
isn't working so well so i'm going to
just jump to the application and now hot
reload works and then i'm going to put
scr cpy on another screen so it doesn't
bother us so much
okay so that's our controller so
we're then gonna work on creating a
function that can display the loading
screen and that function itself is gonna
return a loading screen controller to
you so that's the beauty of that
function using the controller then you
can close the loading screen or update
it so you can see that these two are
basically functions that the call side
can accept and call in order to close
and update the loading screen
respectively
all right that was the loading screen
controller what we need to do now is to
work on the loading screen itself so
um let's go ahead as the caption
indicates we're gonna go to lib helpers
loading in this folder
and we're going to create a new file
inside loading and let's just call it
that loading screen
start
and inside loading screen we're just
going to create a loading screen
class okay
and we're going to make our loading
screen
a singleton and since we've done
singleton twice before i'm just going to
basically paste the pattern in here so
we don't have to write this
boring code again but this is a pattern
that we've done so far twice as i
mentioned before so you should basically
know how it works so we have a private
constructor then we have a factory
constructor which is public which in
turn uses a static final
variable which in turn calls the private
initializer so
it's just a bit of a we could actually
do it like this in so this is in order
basically so when someone calls our
loading screen constructor factory
constructor from outside in turn calls
this and this in turn calls this so it's
a it's a layer base it's three layers
okay so what we're going to do in here
we're also going to keep pulling up our
loading screen controller and so let's
go ahead and send loading screen
controller as you can see it's going to
also import it for me so i'm just going
to say loading screen controller and
let's just say it's optional
because we might not actually have it
and um then what we're gonna do in here
we're gonna have a function called show
as i can see
and um
then we're gonna have a few more
functions there that are gonna allow us
to control basically our loading screen
and i wonder which one is actually best
to
um
best to
work with first
it could be that we should be working
for instance with the
show overlay function so let's go ahead
and do that so let's say that we are
going to have a function on our loading
screen um class and we're calling it
show overlay so and this show overlay is
then in turn going to return an instance
of loading screen controller so let's go
ahead and start writing that so loading
screen controller
and we say show overlay
and this function has a two required
parameters so i'm going to put curly
bracket in here a curly bracket in here
and let's just say we need a build
context so build contacts and
it's going to auto import from material
so that's great build context
and require parameter build context and
i'm just going to call it context and
then upon you wanting to show an overlay
you also have to specify its text so
because
what we're saying in here is that an
overlay can't be displayed without an
actual text in it okay and remember
we're using the word overlay but in this
case our loading screen is going to have
a custom overlay with some material
components like a column and button etc
etc okay so show overlay in this case
means show the loading screen with this
text okay
so we call it that and then let's go
ahead and basically say this is a string
of text just like that okay
and
perfect so that's fine so now what we're
going to create now is um we're going to
create a stream controller
that
will then
new strings that are provided by this
controller remember we created this
thing so if someone updates the loading
screen text we're going to put those
strings inside a stream controller so
let's go ahead and create a final
if i can spell
so we'll say this is a stream controller
control controller of string okay
we just create that and it can't find
stream controller so i'm just going to
say import lib dart async so that's
another import um right here which you
might have to do by hand if you don't
have visual studio code or if you're not
using for instance a text editor or id
that can also import things for you
stream controller is available in dart
async
so then the first thing we're going to
do is to add the current text
into
our stream controller so this text
parameter that was provided to us we're
going to put it inside the stream
controller okay
so
what we need to do is basically
use a new function that we haven't used
before which is called overlay of
context so
if i look at if you look at the return
of this it will return something called
an overlay state and it says the state
from the closest instance of this class
that encloses the given context so we
need this state in order to be able to
display our overlay so let's just grab
this overlay of context and put it
inside a state
like this
and then what we're going to do is
since overlays are kind of displayed on
top of everything else that's on the
screen they don't have intrinsic sizes
as such so if you're using with if
you're using for instance material
components such as
various widgets inside your flutter
application if you create different
containers buttons they have some sort
of intrinsic size in them however with
overlays you kind of have to grab like
the
state of the current screen and what
components are displayed on and
available with the available height
so we need
some sort of a size
to basically base our overlay on top of
so let's go ahead and grab our render
box
and i'm going to say using this context
and we're going to get find render
object
like this as a renderer box okay so
there's lots of documentation available
about what render box is but it is kind
of like low level and i'm not gonna go
into so much details about that but
let's go actually have a look a little
bit here as you can see it's a render
object and it is quite low level as i
mentioned inside rendering box and what
it will do it will allow you to
basically extract the available
size that our overlay can
have on the screen so let's go ahead and
create a final size in here and say
render box
about size okay so that's that
then what we need to do we actually need
to now create our overlay so our overlay
and you may think oh this is the overlay
because we call it overlay here well
it's not really because the overlay is
like the over um
in in this context that's overlay of
is the state of the
parent overlay uh context so
uh what you are going to create in your
application is actually called overlay
entry so um but when when we say we're
going to create an overlay what we
actually mean is an overlay entry okay
so let's go ahead and create an overlay
entry in here so we're gonna say final
overlay is overlay entry just like that
and then we have a builder function
now i'm gonna get visual studio code to
complete this it needs a context all
right so let's go in here now
overlays they don't have a parent like a
scaffold or anything so if you don't
wrap your
like this component that you return from
your builder which should be a widget
let's go in here you can see it's a
widget if you don't wrap this inside
some sort of a material component such
as scaffold or material itself your
overlay is going to have horrible
styling because it's not going to have
any default system styling so excuse me
what we're going to do in here we're
going to return a material component
and material is going to allow you if
you look here
as a documentation of material it says
creates a
piece of letter
i mean okay um but what it basically
means it is actually let's have a look
at this code maybe that makes more sense
so
uh is a stateful widget so it will
create a stateful widget for you which
has some default styling so you can put
your components in there and they'll be
style according to the system skin okay
so let's say that we are going to give
the material which is going to cover the
entire screen this material component
that we're returning here is going to
cover the entire screen remember so
let's first paint the entire screen with
kind of like a dark color as you know
when you display like errors or
dialogues to the screen to the user
usually what they do is like they paint
the background the entire background
kind of like a dark color so then they
can display their dialogue in the middle
of the screen and kind of give it kind
of
like um
some sort of a
elevation so it kind of it pops out of
the screen a little bit so what we're
going to do in here we're going to say
color the color of our material uh
staple widget in here is colors black
with alpha of 150 okay
and then the child of our material then
it's gonna be a center okay so that's
what we're gonna create here so
let's then go in here and what we're
going to do is the child of this is
going to be container so i'm just going
to create a container here and then put
a semicolon there and it's happy now
so then our content container is gonna
place some constraints off on our
overlay so it's gonna say for instance
that its max width and height should be
a certain value so we haven't used this
before but we're gonna now use something
called constraints in here and you can
see the value of constraints is of type
box constraints so let's say constraints
and then we say box constraints okay so
we're going to start with max width
so then we're going to say size width
multiplied by zero at that eight and
what we're basically saying here saying
that this
this dialogue that we're displaying to
the user is going to consume at most
eighty percent of the available widths
on the screen so this is our way of
creating some margins to the right and
left for those of you who are web
developers and are like know about
margin um
and even if you're a web even if you're
a designer you'll probably know already
about margin so what we're saying is
that this container needs to wrap itself
around its contents but if the contents
grow it's gonna go at most eighty
percent
of the available width and this width is
coming from our render box okay
so that's that and we're gonna do the
same thing with max height so we're
going to say size height multiplied 0.8
and then we're going to give it a min
width of size with multiply 0.5 so we're
going to say at least it should it
should grab um half of the screen width
okay
then let's give it some decoration so
we're going to say this is box
decoration so let's go in here
and so this is just to give it some um
border so uh usually dialogues or in
this case an overlay that we're
displaying to use or they have some sort
of a border so it creates this kind of
like a beautiful elevation so if this is
the dark background in here which we
created with black of alpha 150 then we
have an arc basically overlaying here or
overlay um we call it here as you can
see overlay entry then the overlay entry
will be placed here but it will have
some border around it to
separate it from the background okay so
this is just a technique to separate our
overlay from the background
so we're going to say the border is
color white
our sorry color is white and then we're
going to say it has a border radius
f and border radius
all these documentations on the screen
are just driving me crazy and border
radius.circular and let's just give it a
circle value of 10 in here okay
sometimes documentation is just
in the way
so let's stand in here as you can see
now we have an empty container we should
never do that so let's go in here and
just create a child for it so the child
in here is going to be a padding
so um or maybe we could just say single
child scroll view for now
and then i'm gonna embed the single
child scroll view inside padding that's
that's my preferred way of doing this so
just like that and let's just give it
padding of 16 for now okay
so the reason that the child of this
padding that we created here is a single
child scroll view is as you remember we
said the max height of our overlay entry
is 80 of the available height on the
screen
that's all great and
but what if
your just your application display on a
very small screen and
then you're displaying a lot of text
well if you don't put your contents in
the entire contents of your material
widget inside a single child scroll view
then your content is going to be
basically chopped so the users are not
going to see the content in its entirety
and what single chat scroll view does is
that it tries to not scroll its contents
if the content has enough space to be
displayed on the container but if the
contents overflows the container's
height for instance then it's going to
allow the user to scroll on that
container so it it works perfectly trust
me
so let's go in here and then go and
inside the single chart scroll view
create a child and in here we're going
to have a column
and our main axis size is going to be
main axis
main axis size of minimum because
remember if you don't give a main
exercise a minimum pure column your
column is going to grab as much space as
it can so it's just going to expand as
much as it can and if you say main
exercise is minimum it's just gonna
basically try to
hug its contents as much as it can
and then we're gonna say main access
alignment is main access alignment of
center so it's also going to place its
contents vertically in the center okay
then what we're going to do in here in
column children so let's go in here and
say children then let's create a size
box um and give it a height of 10 so
we're creating some top margin from
um from top of the column so this is
saying that we have a column we're going
to put some stuff in it but give it 10
points of
emptiness on top so it just creates a
little bit of a margin okay and look i
fully understand that this is a lot of
abstract stuff it would be a lot nicer
if you could actually see this on the
screen
but sometimes when you're programming
especially in flutter since it's so
declarative then you have to kind of use
your imagination on how this thing is
actually going to look like on the
screen
so
you could do a lot of experiments and
test this for your for yourself and just
maybe just even do this don't do
anything more than this just use a size
block on the size box on the screen and
just display it overlay and see how it
looks like that also works okay
and right after this let's go and create
a
our const of circular progress indicator
so that's going to be a little indicator
that sits there and displays that
something is loading
and then we're going to give it another
size box with a height of maybe this
time actually 20 and so this creates a
little bit more spacing
and then what we're doing in here we
want to create a text
and but that text could change because
that text is placed inside the stream
controller so we're not going to use a
stream builder so let's say stream
builder
like this
and our stream
itself is this text
um
right
that we created up
there so what we need to do basically is
to grab the stream from the stream
controller and use it inside our stream
builder and then i'm going to help from
visual studio coding here and say that
the builder function should be like
and if you remember we could use a
really handy
getter on our snapshot that says has
data so let's say return or sorry um you
say if snapshot has data then we're
going to return a text in here okay
and the text basically is it's the text
of the text widget is going to be the
snapshots data as string we know that it
is a string
and also we are going to give it a text
alignment of text align in the center
okay
so that's that part and let's put a
comma in there as well
and also we're we're getting this error
right now because we're not returning a
widget in all the available paths inside
this builder and we have to put an else
statement in here
and otherwise we just can return a
container as you can see in here okay so
since we have to return something we
could just return an empty container for
now
i mean you could also solve this in
another way for instance say okay if the
snapshot has data i'm going to return a
text like this or otherwise i'm going to
return a text
like an empty text like this
you could also try to do that but right
now we're just leaving it as returning a
container okay
so
that's that part
now we created our
up until this point so if i
do this and
fold this that we created in here which
is our overlay we've just created the
overlay that doesn't mean that we're
displaying it so the way to display an
overlay is to use that overlay of which
created an overlay state and say insert
overlay okay so this actually adds our
overlay to the entire overlay state that
flutter manages on the screen so
so now we've done that so what we need
to do then upon upon this happening we
need to
take our return statement and that's why
we're seeing a red
basically loading screen dart file here
in visual studio code depending
depending on your editor or id that
you're using you may or may not see this
screen as having an error but if you
scroll up in here it basically tells you
that well you're not returning what you
said you should return so let's go in
here and create an instance of loading
screen
um controller
okay
and we have to take care of the close
and we have to also take care of the
update but let's take care of closed
first so it's an empty function
and the only thing it should do is to
have a look at our stream controller and
close that
and then we have we go to our overlay
that we just created and basically
remove it from the screen
and also we just say yeah we returned
through from this okay and now we're
getting an error in here saying update
it's not provided so let's go ahead and
create update as well and if you
remember from update uh what it does it
actually takes the string as a parameter
in itself so
in here the only thing we have to do is
to add that to our stream controller so
i just noticed that you can't see the
code sorry about that so
let's add that and just return true and
to be honest with you you could just say
well let's just not return any value in
here you could do that as well but i
created these
um function signatures so that you can
also indicate an error to the call site
so
you may try to get rid of these
yeah let's go ahead and do that if you
want to but i'm just going to leave it
like this in case we want to extend this
functionality in the future so that we
can return false if things go wrong okay
all right that was the uh let's say that
was our show overlay function so that's
perfect so
let's then go ahead and create a
function in here that we're going to
call also height now we have show let's
go create hide okay
so let's just say void hide like this
and what we're gonna do in here we're
gonna take our controller like this and
if it's there we're just gonna say close
okay remember close the way it was
implemented it
closes the stream controller for text
and it also removes the overlay and
returns true so that's gonna if there is
a controller available on the screen
then it's gonna return that okay sorry
it's gonna close that
so um and also we're just gonna say
controller is null
all right
so and the point for us is that to show
to use this function internally remember
this this function is going to return
this loading screen controller which
we are soon going to place inside this
controller variable at the moment
control variable is always basically
null all right
all right that's great stuff so now
we've taken our taking care of hide so
now that we have hide let's go and
create show so we say show and then we
need two parameters in here
two required parameters so let's say
required build context build context
context
and then we say required string text
okay so anybody calling this function
has to provide these two parameters and
they're very familiar because they are
the parameters needed by show overlay
okay
so let's go in here and we say if we
have a controller um if we can actually
use this controller's update function in
here so like this
and we pass the text in here or false
so now you probably are like starting to
see why i'm returning true from this
function and that's because well if you
don't have a controller then you can't
update it okay
so this basically
what it does it makes the
code you have to write shorter because
otherwise you'd have to do like this if
controller
not null
then you would have to update but in
here we're just saying either update the
controller's text
or
else like this okay so
if we could update the controller's x we
just return because that means well we
already have a controller on the screen
a an overlay controller so we could
update its text so show should just
return right after that it shouldn't
display a new um overlay otherwise we
create and we basically create a new
overlay using this show overlay and
assign it to our controller
our property on top so we say this is
equal to show orally
with that context and text
all right fantastic so that's pretty
much all we have to do and for our
loading screen.dart file so we could
just save this and i'm just going to
save this file as well and close it
so let's talk a little bit about our um
off
state
and if you remember from our off state
and for instance here we have off state
logged out and that has a has is loading
um property in here but if you look at
for instance needs verification or
logged in etc etc
they don't have is loading so
what if we added is loading to a higher
level here to our off state so any off
state in our application could
potentially be in the loading state as
well so that means registering could be
loading logging could be loading whoever
wants to could have loading
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
now so i'm going to go to my notes as
well so off state
let's go ahead and add these
parameters that we have at the bottom of
the screen to our off state okay so i'm
going to say final um
bool is loading
and also let's say final string
loading text something like this
and then let's just
undefine class build sorry about that i
just programmed so many different
languages um at final and they're so so
different every language is kind of like
they have their own data types and
typescript has their own lowercase data
types uppercase etc
it's just a mishmash of various
different types i just wish we could get
along and have like one standard for all
data types at least the primary data
types in our applications
but that's just wishful thinking maybe i
digress let's go ahead and add these
parameters to our off state
and let's go ahead and do this make
these required parameters so we say it's
it should uh this should be provided is
loading but the loading text doesn't
need to be provided we'll always have a
default we'll say please wait a moment
like this
uh and we should close this have i not
closed this
so like that okay
so that's adding these two parameters to
our um auth state and loading text
always has a default string okay
so let's go ahead to auth state
uninitialized and add is loading in here
so let's say required
bool is loading so now that we've done
that we should actually you see now what
we're getting in here is saying that
wait you're not calling your super
because it's a super has this is loading
parameter in here that you need to
provide because it's required but you're
not doing that so let's go ahead and
actually add that parameter to our cells
as well and say is loading
and what we're doing here which is
called super and we say is loading is is
loading as is provided to us okay
so that's for uninitialized
um now let's go to registering and do
the same thing in in there so we're
going to say for registering we actually
have exception required so let's make
this required and also make
is loading required so it is loading
like that
okay and let's call super is loading is
is loading like this
all right perfect
that's also done and for
registering let's go to
auth states logged in at the moment
we're getting taking the user
and you see i'm making these parameters
required because
if you don't make them required as soon
as you go to two parameters three
parameters for creating a cons for
constructing
an object using this initializer then
things start to get messy because
they're not named parameters otherwise
so passing three unnamed parameters to
an initializer to me is just it's just a
little bit difficult to understand so
that's why we're making them required
okay
so let's go in here and make this also
required
name parameter required if i can spell
and this user
and then i'm gonna say required uh bool
is
uh required bull is loading all right
like that and then let's call super is
loading with is loading all right
so that's for off state logged in
now we need to also think about off
state needs a verification and we're
just gonna take is loading in there as
well
so let's go ahead and say needs
verification also has a required
parameter
bool is loading and we're gonna do the
same thing super is loading it is
loading so all we're doing is that we're
making sure that every state has and is
loading and that is loading is passed to
the super class called off state all
right
and then we need to take care of also
our off state logged out so
and
you see at the moment we have a little
problem in here and it says don't
overwrite fields thank you dart and that
means basically it's loading is already
implemented on the super class so we
could just safely remove it from here
okay and then we say bool
is loading and actually required bull
actually like that
and also we take in a string of um our
loading text like this
um so
now that that is like that we're just
gonna call super and say is loading is
equal to is loading and then loading
text is loading text just like that okay
and then put a comma at the end of this
perfect all right so that is basically
saying that we may want to customize the
off state logged out loading text
because we're taking it in and then
passing it up to the super whereas the
others are not allowing us at the moment
to customize their
loading text so that's why we have
string loading text only for off state
locked out and not for the other classes
all right
um
okay
so that's that so we've already
basically taken care of this caption as
well so we've added loading text to our
auth state logged out okay
so now we need to save this file and
just go back to our off block in here
and you can see now we have a little bit
of a problem in here so let me also go
to my notes so i can bring up my notes
off block
so we have our
um
auth state uninitialized in here and
what we need to do is say when the
application opens when you the
absolute initial state of the
application should be in the loading
state so we should say it's loading true
okay
so that's that part we taking care of
that
so i need to what we need to do now is
to take care of as you say update off
state logged out in off block so
let's go and find
logged out
and we can have a look in here let's see
if we have logged out anywhere yes and
it says add is loading true to off state
logged out while loading
so um i'm gonna have a look here and see
if we can actually find that so that's
for instance um
here
and that's fine and then what we're
gonna do in here we're gonna say loading
text
and let's say please wait while i log
you in something like this okay
that's off state logged out that's the
first thing that we have to do and let's
see where else we're using off state
logged out and sorry
here
yes and that's fine that's fine
so maybe that was the only place that we
actually had to update our log state uh
off state logged out
i don't think we have anywhere else that
off state logged out has to be set to
true except for when we're actually
logging you in so
and i believe that we've done that now
so off state logged out is there with is
loading true there so that's that's the
only thing we have to do okay
the next thing that we have to do is to
add is loading to other states in off
block so let's start from where we're
getting all these errors so we have
excuse me off event initialize so i'm
going to find that in my notes in here
and in these cases when we're emitting
auth state needs verification we should
just say is loading false because you
see
when we actually end up in this state
we're not loading anything we've already
done the work that we were supposed to
do so
and that's sufficient basically in here
so here we have the user so now this is
a required parameter named parameter so
it has its user and then we're going to
say it's loading
and in here we're going to say false as
well so command here to make the code
look a little bit better
and let's then go ahead in here which is
our off event login
and we have
this problem at the end which is off
state needs verification
and when we've emitted this off state
needs verification is loading is also
false so pretty much is loading is false
almost everywhere
except for when we're actually loading
something
which is for instance uh let's see
here
when we're actually logging in for
instance okay so when we have the user
in here we say user is a required
parameter and is loading is false as
well
coma to make it work also
and just looking up and down this file i
can see we also have a problem off event
register so let's go to auth event
register
excuse me and let's just say auth needs
verification is loading is false as well
and in here we have an exception name
parameter i believe and they require
parameter and then we say is loading is
false as well so just a comma in there
to get the formatting working
and that is working as it should so we
shouldn't have any errors basically in
our offline at this point all right
so then i'm gonna close that file
so
what we need to do as the captioning
case we need to go to our login view and
remove everything that has anything to
do with
loading so let's go to a login view
and in here
uh login
view
and at the moment you can see we have
this closed dialog close dialog handle
all that stuff so we shouldn't do any of
that so now you see the point of what
we've done is for our application to be
able to handle
the loading dialog just in one place
loading dialogue should be handled in
one place in the entire application
that's what we're trying to do we
shouldn't have loading states and
loading like handling loading and or any
dialogues and that has anything to do
with loading in various views inside our
application so that's what we're trying
to get to okay so let's first go to this
close dialogue handle and remove that
because we're not going to need that
anymore and then let's go in here and
remove all this code inside your login
view dot dart file that has anything to
do with loading so now you should just
have exception handling all right
oh now let's go to um
our main dart file and
here have a look at what we have you can
see at the moment we have a block
builder inside the main widget of home
page in in our build function we have a
block builder but what we want is to
issue some side effects
when the state
changes to something that has a loading
in it okay so you see this state at the
moment is off state but inside there
this state could have is loading set to
true so how do we handle that remember
block builder is not supposed to have
any side effects that's the job of the
block listener
however we need the block builder we
actually need to return something in
here we need to return
different views depending on the current
state but we also need a block listener
so how do we do this how do we fix this
well the the solution is using a block
consumer
so a block consumer i've mentioned this
before the block consumer
builds on top of a block builder and a
block listener so it allows you to do
both things at the same time so if you
ever end up in a situation or
application where you want a builder a
blog builder and you want a blog
listener block listener at the same time
there is where you need a blog consumer
okay
so let's go in here and say that in our
main file i'm going to go to my notes as
well
and i'm just going to say
excuse me in here
we don't have a block builder
instead we have a block
consumer
and now we have listener in here and
let's grab hold of this so
what we're going to do in here is say if
state is loading
then what we're going to say is we're
going to say loading screen and it also
imported for me okay and then we're
gonna say show
okay we have the context already and
then we either take the state's loading
text or we say please wait in a moment
so if the state's loading text is not
available we just use a default one in
here
so if the state is not loading we just
say loading screen
dot height all right so that's that so
now that we've done this this is pretty
much like the last building block that
we have to build inside this um inside
this application for now so i'm just
going to close this main dart file and
resize the screen let's go ahead and
bring up scrcpy
and if i dare i'm gonna hot restart the
application entirely because we've done
so much new work
and let's go ahead in uh just for
experiment i'm gonna go into
what is it loading okay i'm just gonna
go into our
provider
in firebase auth provider inside this
login
if you remember from before
it user
login in here
like this we could basically have a
little bit of a delay so because
otherwise we may not actually see the
our little uh overlay so i'm just gonna
first not do that and try to log in
normally so fubar bass
you saw did you see our little overlay
there so i'm going to log out now and
see if we can see it
what we didn't
but if i try to now put a little bit of
a delay in here so i'm just going to say
await
um
future
delayed the rate const duration
seconds three
and just hot restart the application
and then i'm going to say
my normal credentials foo bar
and press the login button and this is
our overlay
right and it has the ability for you to
actually update its text as it's
displayed on the screen so
then yes everything is actually working
as it should so now we have an overlay
we don't have our loading dialog anymore
so you could safely basically go and say
well i want to get a complete rid of
the loading dialog so i'm going to leave
that up to you
as now that we did we don't need the
loading dialogue so what we achieved in
this chapter is actually huge because we
now have a loading um screen that is
independent of the entire application
and it's in just one place that's the
goal we don't have many different places
in our application that are handling the
loading dialogue okay
so let's go ahead and make sure we're
not going to lose our code our precious
code that we've written so far so i'm
gonna rid of i'm gonna get rid of scr
cpy increase the size of the screen
and let's go as we usually do and commit
and tag our code so if you look at our
logs the previous commit was step 25
let's
add
everything and say git commit
step
i'm going to push these changes and
let's just say git tag
step 26 as well
and then get push
tags if i can spell
but if you look at our logs now so we
have step 26 in here and if i scroll a
little bit step 25 is before it and all
the tags are also available in here you
can see 25 and 26 available right there
all right so we've done what we promised
to do at the beginning of this chapter
and we created a great overlay that we
can reuse in the in the application and
just show and hide only in one place
so what we need to do now is the very
exciting stuff in that we're getting
really close to being complete with our
application so we have login register
verification
email verification we have loading in
screens we have sharing deleting it's
just we have pretty much everything for
application but
we still have some little bits and
pieces left to make the application more
useful because remember when you create
your application and send it to apple
and google for review there's actually
going to be real people who sit there
and interact with your application to
see if they can make sense of it so we
need to clean the ui up so that it's a
little bit more user friendly and that's
exactly what we're going to take care of
in the next chapter so i'll see you
there hello everyone and welcome to
chapter 44 of the swata course in
previous chapters we've been basically
working quite a lot with block and we've
been making sure that our applications
loading screen is working so we have one
place in the entire application that
we're taking care of the loading screens
and we also have wrapped our whole
authentication process inside a block
and we're very now close to being able
to release our application to the app
store apple's app store and google's
play store
so
this is usually what we do as software
developers
just before releasing our product or we
basically go and clean it up as we say
so we put some final touches to it so
even if you're a designer you usually do
that probably like if you're working
with figma or you're working with sketch
you first are like designing your
product and then before you present it
to the product owner or the developers
you probably put some final touches to
it so um that's what we're gonna do in
this chapter and we have um a few things
also left to do which have nothing
really to do with the final touches to
the ui it's mainly to do with the
products functionality and we'll talk
about that first
so if you think about it what we have at
the moment is um
an application that a user can register
they can't send an email verification
they can log in and they can go into the
list of notes that they have they can
create notes delete notes and edit and
share notes however we haven't really
exposed a functionality for a user to be
able to reset their password so
imagine a process imagine an application
where you've created it created a user
in the application and you forgot your
password and there's absolutely no way
for you to get back into the product or
the software and because you just don't
know your password so you
may then have to personally contact the
application developer and say could you
reset my password so it's a very very
difficult process to do manually and you
shouldn't really do that so what we're
going to do
we're going to do in this chapter is not
only to do final ui touches but also
we're going to create a password reset
functionality into our application
so let's get started with that i'm going
to do some screen reshuffling in here as
you can see in the cache we're going to
go delete all users in firebase console
and also all their data
so
i'm going to bring up console
firebase.com and i'm going to bring it
to the main screen in here
let's find our application i believe
it's this one and i'm then gonna go in
here
to a firebase date the firestore
database and let's start by
going in here and deleting
these documents so let's say delete
document and we have four documents so
it's nothing
so difficult to do
just one at a time we delete these
documents okay here here
and those are our documents gone so you
could just keep your collection i think
it's best because our application at the
moment is assuming that there is a node
collection available
if you remember from our node service
so that's that part we deleted the data
but we haven't really deleted the user
so let's go off to authentication
section of your
firebase
and in here i'm just gonna say delete
account
and let's just delete this account as
well so now we're basically starting off
fresh so no users and no data in the
entire
and back end all right
so that's that part let's do that i'm
going to then bring up our source coding
here
let's see
so here
we have our
my notes application as we've called it
so that's visual studio code i'm going
to resize it a little bit and then i'm
going to bring up scrcpy as well which
has our app running at the moment and
the application thinks at the moment
that we're logged in
because it hasn't really communicated
with the back end yet so i'm gonna just
do a hot restart in here and this is
this is the problem that you'll
sometimes actually notice in the in your
application in that
firebase isn't gonna immediately
understand that this user doesn't exist
on the back end anymore so if you delete
a user from your firebase backend it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
immediately going to be reflected to the
application so let's see what happens in
here if i then log out with this user
like this and then try to log in with a
user that used to exist in the
application but i just deleted it foo
barbado
and let's see what happens in here and
now you can see we see we say user not
found okay we're gonna clean up that
message as well soon in this chapter
so good we have a clean slate now so we
have no users and no data in the
application
um
so what we need to do now is to start by
defining our events and states for
forgotten password okay so if user says
hey i forgot my password we have to have
an event
so that we can send that event
to our um
off block
so you can see in here we have to go to
auth event dark file and add an auth
event for god password okay
so let's go ahead and do that so i'm
going to open off event dark file
and perhaps
over log out in here we're just going to
say class i'm going to increase the size
in here as well obviously better
class um off as we've said in the notes
here off event forgot password extends
off
event okay just like that
and in here we need to grab the user's
email so we say email
like that and i'm gonna create a
constructor for this as well just like
that
and let's just make this
or here with curly brackets okay
all right so it's a name parameter now
um and we just said auth event forgot
password
fantastic so that's that part um then we
also need to go and define a state
because when a user presses a button for
instance saying i forgot my password
then our off block is going to produce
that state and say hey application that
your state right now is forgot password
and then in the main dart file as you'll
soon see we will go and edit and add
that state to our state handling as you
can see in your main dart file
the moment we have all these states but
we're going to add a new state that says
else if state is off state forgot
password then display a forgot password
view which we're also gonna develop soon
so
as the caption indicates let's go and
let's go to the file off state dart file
and i'm going to do that in my notes as
well after registering it really doesn't
matter where you place that code i'm
just going to place it here after
registering
and just say off state forgot password
and off state
um
and then we have to also take care of
this so
what should the state actually indicate
to the application
let's say that when you're in the forgot
password view which we're soon gonna
develop
um there could be two things that you
wanna convey to the user in that screen
either the user has just landed so there
are actually three three states that
that screen can have
either the user has just landed on that
screen meaning that there is no errors
nothing we haven't done anything so it's
just a clean slate so that's the default
state
of off state forgot password so nothing
okay
however what if the user has actually
pressed the
um
send reminder email because you see the
way we're going to handle for a password
is we're going to actually ask firebase
and say firebase this user forgot their
password with this email send a reminder
email to them or send some kind of like
an email to them that they can't
actually reset their password
so upon user pressing that button to
send a reminder email to their email
address
um a few things can happen
actually two things that we're going to
handle one is that well
we tried to send an email but it didn't
succeed so kind of an exception so
that's the second state remember no
state
second state is there's an exception and
there's a third state that there was no
exception but we've actually sent the
email so three things we have to handle
okay
so the default state with no values is
state number one nothing has happened
state number two would be actually
having an optional accept exception here
and the third state is um
bull
has sent email like this okay
so let me go ahead and create a
constructor for these i'm not gonna
explain this again because we've talked
about this quite a lot and i'm gonna
make these required parameters okay just
like that
and put a semicolon at the end
and in here we're just gonna call em
we're gonna call super but remember from
super off states has a constructor here
that has to provide is loading okay so
in in this case let's just actually take
a bull is loading as well as a parameter
in here
and then we're gonna pass is loading to
our super as well just like that
all right
so
when we're actually working with this
auth state for that password we can
actually give it is loading parameter
and that's going to get delegated back
to off state so our main dart file is
going to be able to display a loading
screen if is loading is true if you
remember from
main dart file we have this beautiful
block consumer with the listener that
that looks at any off state and as long
as this auth states is loading parameter
is true or that auth states is loading
variable or property is true then it
shows the loading screen
all right perfect so now we've taken
care of off state so we didn't make any
changes in main dart file yet okay
all right what we need to do is now go
to our um auth provider dart file and
define an interface function for sending
a reminder email so
i'm gonna go and do that right now auth
provider
i'm gonna do it here as well off
okay
so let's go ahead and define a function
that every auth provider including our
firebase auth provider has to conform to
okay so let's say this is a future
point and we call it send password
reset like that and we have a required
string parameter to email just like that
so this is now defined
after defining this you'll understand
now soon that we have a few errors
because auth service conforms to auth
provider
and so does firebase auth provider but
we're gonna fix these soon okay
so as the caption indicates let's go to
firebase auth provider in here and
actually implement that so i'm gonna go
to firebase
off
provider in my notes
and i'm also going to go here on the
screen and say um firebase
off provider and you'll see an error in
here in visual studio code you can
actually get help from visual studio
code to complete that missing overwrite
for us you can see create one missing
override and this is basically saying
that you're conforming to auth provider
but you're not actually overwriting all
the functions that boss provider wants
you to override okay so if you're
working with vim or if you're working
with sublime that doesn't for instance
have dart's um
plugin then you may have to override
that function yourself but the signature
of that function is very easy you can
just go to auth provider and grab this
function and just put a
override before it okay so that's
completely fine as well but since i'm
working with and this is asking me to
save this file but there's pretty much
nothing that i did in this file already
okay
so since i have visual studio code i can
ask it to create the missing override
for me and it's gonna probably create it
right at the bottom in here okay so
that's fine
so let's put this whole thing into a
catch block so i'm just gonna say catch
like this
all right and then if anything happens
during this process of sending a
password reset email to the user we're
just gonna throw
a generic auth exception in here okay so
then um and also if you're wondering
about this syntax this is just like you
ignoring an incoming variable in swift
and in rust and some other languages
like python you could also do something
like this that you ignore an incoming
variable using underscore but in dart
it's not really you ignoring ignoring
the variable it's you naming the
variable
underscore but i try to sometimes use
this just to indicate that hey i don't
care about this variable okay but just
know that internally you're not ignoring
it you're just naming it underscore okay
so let's go in here and and now ask our
provider so um so we just say await
since we're in firebase auth provider we
can actually say wait firebase off
oh and we have to mark this function as
async otherwise we can't use a weight
and then instance and then there's a
function called send password reset
email and it it says to which email and
we're gonna say to this email okay
all right so that's our catch in there
but we also have to have another catch
that is that catches firebase off
exception as we're doing in many other
places so let's have a look
um here for instance okay so let's go
before this catch and say on firebase
off exception
catch e something like that
and then curly brackets and curly
brackets close so i'm going to bring
this code up so we see better
so there are two things that we have to
handle two codes that we have to handle
as you can see we're handling a few
codes in here for instance user not
found wrong password and these things
are basically
i haven't really found the correct
documentation for these things like
where firebase has documented that these
errors are going to happen with these
codes it's mainly that i found them out
through experience just like trying
different things and seeing that things
fail and upon failing i caught their
error code and now i know which error
codes i had to actually have to handle
but if you search on google i'm pretty
sure you're gonna find some good
documentation about a firebase and the
google team are great at documenting
things so
so one error that we have to handle is
called firebase auth invalid email and
the other one call is called firebase
off user not found so let's first
grab the um error code so i'm just going
to say switch e code in here because
remember
any firebase auth exception that comes
from firebase has a code of type string
as you can see here and that's that
string that we're interested in so let's
handle firebase auth invalid email for
now okay
and then in this case we're just going
to say throw um invalid email off
exception oops
we already have this defined from before
okay
in our off exceptions here dark file you
see
and the other case that we have to
handle is called
firebase auth user not found so it's a
user it's like anyone asking for a
reminder email for their password and
that user just doesn't exist in the
database so then we have to handle that
case as well it's called user not found
just like that okay and then we're gonna
throw
a user not found off exception
in any other case of firebase
authexception we're just going to throw
generic off exception just like that
okay
and we're going to save this file
fantastic so we fixed firebase auth
provider but if you look at your project
explorer you still have a problem in
auth service because if you remember
auth service also implements auth
provider but it delegates all its
responsibility to its auth provider
so let's go into our auth service and
implement the send password reset
functionality so i'm just going to go in
here
and get a visual studio code to complete
this with command dot on mac or control
dot and linux and windows and just say
create one missing override okay and in
here i'm making this an arrow function
because i believe every other function
we've done in here is an error function
since
all these functions inside all servers
as i've stated before
basically delegate their functionality
to the provider
which is given to it inside its
constructor
so let's go ahead and create an error
function and in here just delegate this
to the provider and we just say provider
send
email
verification and in here we just say um
send password resets actually called
sorry provider send password reset to
email to email just like that
all right and let's just save this file
then um
[Music]
so
what we need to do now
is to actually handle our auth event for
god password in the off box so
i understand there's lots of like
jargons that are flying around here so
you may just be a bit confused about
okay what are we actually doing so what
we need to do now is you see
soon what we're going to do is to create
a little button in here
and
say forgot password so when the user
lands in the login screen they may be
like okay this is my email but i
actually forgot my password so they have
to have a forgot password button
somewhere here
upon them pressing that button
in the login view we're gonna send this
event to our off block so if you
remember from our off event so i'm going
to go back here you don't have to go
here if you go to our off events you can
see we have an auth event forgot
password so the goal is for our user
and for
for our user interface to send this
events to the auth block and then off
block is going to calculate its state
based on that okay
so let's go now into our auth block file
here as you can see
and i'm going to do that here
in my code as well and we're going to go
and implement
um
this functionality here forgot password
like this and let's go and say on off
event
forgot password just like that and you
now should be
quite used to this syntax emit
and this is going to be asynchronous
function and just uh curly brackets just
like that so this is like the bare bones
of handling
an event in your block
okay now we're handling off event for a
god password so what we're gonna do in
here is we're just gonna say
uh by default we're emitting
a constant
off state for a god password
exception is null has sent email is
false
and it's loading is false so what we're
basically saying in here is saying by
the user pressing the forgot password
button what we're doing is saying
yeah go to the forgot password screen
that's all that's all we're saying okay
because then our main dart file is gonna
handle this it's gonna say okay if this
date is forgot password i'm just gonna
go to the forgot password screen okay
so then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna extract the user's email from this
event if there is an email in there it
means that the user was in the fargot
password screen and actually press the
button to send a forgot password email
to themselves okay so
if that's not the case then we know that
all the user did is just to go to that
screen so there is no email to handle so
let's just say final and if i can spell
oops
final email is event email and we say if
email is null then we just return
meaning that yeah the user it seems like
the user just wanted to go to the forgot
password screen okay
so that's that's that now
if that is not the case so let's just
put a comment in here user just wants to
go to forgot password
screen
and if we end up in here in line 21 for
me user wants to actually send a forgot
password email okay and in this case
let's just emit the exact same state as
we did before but in this case we're
saying loading okay remember
our main dart file is going to catch all
the states that have loading and
actually display our loading screen or
the loading um overlay okay so that's
that part
but then what we're gonna do is let's
just go in here
and we have to actually say in here do a
try catching here so we say cat on
exception
catch
like that
and since we're in our off block we have
access to our provider so let's say we
wait for the provider to send a password
reset to the email just like that okay
and then we have to enable two variables
in here we just say boolean did send
password or set bits and email
and just like that
and we also have an optional exception
like this so the goal is we have a try
and catch block in here and in the try
we just say yeah this email was sent
successfully
because yeah if you don't end up in the
catch block meaning that there's there
was no error
then the email was actually sent
successfully and we will also say the
exception is basically null so we don't
have to
worry about any of those uh
functionalities um
after this point but remember we are
basically saving these two variables in
here so that after the try and catch
block we can actually emit an aust state
for a password with those variables so
this thing is going to go in here in oh
the documentation it's going to go in
here
and this thing is going to go in here
okay and it's loading is going to be
false so that's why we're basically
storing them in here so in the positive
case in the happy path as we call it
we're going to say did send email is
true
and we're gonna say exception is no okay
and in this case that's an email it's
gonna be false and exception is gonna be
e all right so we store those
and let's just then copy this state from
above and let's just paste it in here
so in this case we say hey the exception
is the exception if any
um
invalid oh yeah it can't be constant if
it's a variable so um let me bring it
here again so you can see exception is
the exception like that
it has sent email is going to be it send
email
and um
is loading is false so that's it now we
are emitting that state to the
application
all right so
after all of this you see if and now
that we've handled that event and the
state in our offload we also have to
display some sort of a dialogue to the
user so if you're on the reset password
um screen and you enter you've entered
your email and you say hey send me a
reset um password email
after you've done that we're then going
to display a little dialogue to you and
say hey okay we did that we've sent any
error
an email to you go check your email so
we basically need a dialogue and if you
remember we have a generic dialogue
already so we're just going to reuse
that okay so let's go ahead as the
caption at the bottom of the screen in
the case go and create a file under lib
utilities dialogues called password
reset email sends dialog
so um let's let's go ahead and do that
under i'm gonna close this file as well
have a look at what we have in here and
we have utilities
excuse me dialogs
i'm going to create a new file in here
and just going to call it password
reset
and email send dialogue dot dart okay
and so that's the file and we're just
gonna say this is a future void um
show
password
uh reset sent dialogue all right so it's
a function that just needs a build
context
and we're going to get an error here
simply because um i believe
oh visual studio code imported build
context for me automatically that was
fantastic okay
so we're just gonna return show generic
dialogue okay and you can see this is
also gonna be auto imported we've
already had this function from before
so let me put a comma here and a
semicolon at the end just to get the um
dart formatter to format my code and i'm
just going to in here say this is a
generic void function okay
and for title we're just going to say
password reset like that with a capital
r and the content is also string we can
say we have now sent
you a password
a reset
link
so like this please check your
email for more information
something like that okay and you can
change the string if you want
and for the options it's an error
function that has to return a map and it
has only one button with the value of
null and that's it okay
all right so that's our show password
reset sends dialog um
now what we have to do we also have to
develop the actual view for password
reset so
as the caption at the bottom of the
screen indicates we're gonna go to lib
views
and we're gonna go here you see lib
views and under views we're gonna create
a view called forgot password view so
let me go ahead and do that forgot
password view dot dart okay
and i'm gonna go into my notes as well i
forgot the password view okay
but we're gonna create a stateful widget
in here so that's actually quite a bit
of code that we have to we have to write
but we're gonna take care of that so
it's not a problem so let's go to forgot
password view and the first thing i'm
going to do is to create a stateful
widget with stf in visual studio code
i'm just going to call forgot password
view just like that
and since we need a text field on the
screen and so that the user can enter
their uh email address just like we're
doing in the login view let's go ahead
and create a text editing controller but
before all of that we also have to
import materials so that we get rid of
all these errors that are on the screen
right now so let's go in here and just
create a text editing controller so late
final
text editing controller and let's just
call it controller
and you remember this pattern from
before so i don't have to explain it
again so we go into init state
inside in its state we create the
controller so we say it's a text editing
controller oops
text editing controller
and
in dispose we just dispose of it
basically so controller dot displays
okay so that's
just a boilerplate there's nothing
magical happening in here we're just
preparing that view okay
so what we need to do also in here we're
going to create inside this build
function we're going to return a block
listener because
based on the various states of auth
state forgot password so let's go to
auth state
or god password here based on various
states of this we may have to show or
hide different things for instance
if um
if we know that the has sent email
boolean flag is true then we're gonna
basically clear the text fields value
using the controller's clear function
and we're also going to display that
dialogue that we just wrote
has sent email
blah blah
dialogue
it was a long name
it was let's see in our dialogues
uh where is it in our dialogues if i can
find it it should be under utilities
dialogues and then we we should be
called a password recent email sends
dialogue okay
so we're going to display that
and that is why we need a listener so
inside this build in here what we're
going to do is just going to say we
return um a block listener and this
needs to be auto imported as you can see
and this block listener actually listens
for off block which also needs to be
auto imported so there's lots of imports
and if you don't have a good text editor
like visual studio code unfortunately
you'll have to import all these by hand
and that's just a huge time waste direct
oxy so
i don't usually give advice but um
my advice here at least because i think
it's so important is to get yourself a
good text editor because it makes
development a lot easier if you have
like visual studio code
so we have off block and then the second
and generic parameter is off state which
also needs to be auto imported so
there's if you look at the top of the
file there's quite a few um imports
already that i didn't have to do
manually and so we have a listener let's
get help from visual studio to complete
the listener and we also have a little
um let's see we have a child in our
block listener that we can return so in
here for now let's just say we return a
scaffold as a constant all right so
but we can now work on our listener
first
so inside the listener the only thing
we're the only state that we're
interested in because this is going to
return any off state to us as they
change we're only interested in
um if state if i can spell
is off state forgot password so that's
the only state we're interested in
and then we say if state has sent email
then we're going to control go to
controller and say clear
and then we're gonna await on and
displaying the dialogue so async and
then we're gonna say await
and i forgot the name of our huge file
in here again utilities dialogs and
password reset email so i'm going to
grab this the name of this function at
least okay
so i grab the name of that function
paste it in here and get visual studio
code to auto import it for me okay
and in here the only thing we have to do
is just to pass the context in there so
if the email was sent the password reset
was sent and we're going to say clear
the text on the screen on the controller
and then show the dialog telling the
user hey we sent an email to you
okay however if there's
um exception
like this
then what we're gonna do is to display
an error to the user so we're just gonna
say await
show error dialog
and i think that also got auto imported
again
you see
so then we're going to say error dialog
with that context and then we're going
to say we could not process
your request
please make sure that you are a
registered user or something like that
um and we can say
please make sure that you're a
registered user
or if not and
a user
um
or or if not register a user now by
going back one step okay
so this is just some text i mean you
don't have to write this text it's just
basically saying that if you're in the
forgot password
screen and you're saying that hey i
forgot my password it's my email if we
can't find that email if there's an
exception for instance
then
um we're gonna display this message and
say hey you may not be a registered user
do you want to go back and
register yourself
so
and remember in here you could be you
could try to be more fine-grained
because remember our exceptions in here
off state exception in the case of auth
state forgot password
if you go to our off block um
off block
in this case remember the exceptions
come from the send password reset so
this send password reset if you go to
our
firebase auth provider
send password reset oh my god where did
i end up um
no
firebase auth provider
in this case those exceptions could be
invalid email or user not found so you
could actually try to be clean and in
your auth sorry in your forgot password
view and actually check what kind of
exception that is so i actually think
it's it's better if you do that i'm not
going to do that in for the sake of just
saving some time but you may decide to
go ahead and do that and i encourage you
actually excuse me
to do something like that if you want to
so
what we need to do now um
is we've done the listener so that's
really good but in the child we actually
have to create um
we have to create a um proper scaffold
so
let's go ahead and remove the consonant
in here because at the end we're not
going to end up with a constant scaffold
it's very rare that you'd end up with a
constant scaffold
and in the app bar
i'm just going to say we have an app bar
in here
and it has a title and the title is just
going to be constant text and we're just
gonna say forgot password
okay
some commas in there to get the
formatting
correctly and in the body we're gonna
create a column
this is what i usually like to do create
a column and then i'm going to wrap it
in some padding like this and let's just
say padding of 16 as well okay
so
then
that's that's basically our
main focus in here so we need to work on
a little column in your forgot password
view
so now we have that as the first child
of the column we're going to add a
little const of text in here
and to tell the user actually what they
should do in this screen so let's just
say
and i'm going to grab the text that i
had prepared from before
and paste it in here so i don't have to
actually write this thing again so uh
let's see why is it complaining
what is the actual error um too many
positional arguments okay i've messed up
something in here
right of course because in the column i
added actually didn't say children
so let me remove this
children inside the children first i'm
going to put this text okay so if you
have the same problem like me it's
because you place the text right inside
the column and that's not okay we have
to put it inside children property of
the column okay
and we're going to create a text field
right after this where the user can
actually enter their email address so
let's say text um text field
and in here let's see yeah
but we don't have a comma at the end of
this either so i'm going to put a comma
in here okay text field so the screen
looks a little bit scary right now it's
just because it thinks that it has to be
a constant but it's not a constant so
these little warnings are gonna soon
disappear okay
so let's say keyboard type and it's a
text input type so i'm gonna say text
input type
email address okay
autocorrect on email fields always has
to be false okay you don't want
autocorrect on email fields it's very
annoying
and we autofocus as well so that when
the user ends up on that screen the
textville is automatically focused on
and then we put a controller and after
this the problem with the constants is
gonna go away
so that's fantastic um and then let's
just go and create a little decoration
with a hint so we just say const
input decoration
and we're going to say hint text is
your email address like this okay
so that's that part now we've created
the text field
after this we actually need to have a
text button we actually need two of them
so i'm going to say text button
[Music]
like this
and inside the text button on the first
one it's going to it's going to be the
actual cta call to action meaning that
when the users enter their email address
then they're going to press this button
and this upon pressing this button we're
going to send
the email to them okay so let's say i'm
pressed and this is an empty function
just like this for now and its child is
just going to be const of text
and we're gonna send send me password
reset link
like this
so that's the first i'm gonna copy this
text button actually and paste it again
right after that and in here we're just
gonna say
back to
login the login page and in here we
actually have this functionality from
before in our auth blog so let's just go
inside this and say context read or off
block from the context and then we're
gonna add an event in here and say off
event login so
actually sorry log out
so this is gonna send the user to the
login page okay so that's the second
button handle already
and in the first button let's just grab
the user's email so let's just say email
is controller
text
and
in here we're then going to tell the off
block that it has to send a password
reset to this email so we're just going
to say context dot read off block from
the context and we're going to add and
we're going to say off
event
forgot password
and the email is email just like that
all right
well that's it
actually in this case maybe
yeah it's cleaner not to have a comma in
there because if i put a comma then it
formats a code like this but without
having formats like this which to me in
my opinion is a little bit cleaner okay
so i think now we've implemented that so
this screen should be ready our forgot
password view
so as a caption now at the bottom of the
screen in the case we need to go and
look for the off state for god password
and return for god password view in main
dark file
so i'm gonna go to main dark file um
[Music]
so let's let me close this and close
this and let's go to main dart file and
we are handling already quite a lot of
states and right after here login view
excuse me
let's then say
else if state is off state for a god
password just like that
curly brackets
and in here then we're going to say
return
const forgot password view and this is
going to be also imported as well okay
so that's it
oh um
that's that's that part uh our forgot
password
and what we also need to do is to make
sure
inside our login view so let's go into
our login view now
we need to have a little button in here
that allows the user to go to the
foreground password view so we're gonna
add that in here so i'm just gonna
create another text button so copy the
text button that you have at the bottom
and paste it in between in here okay and
in this text right now we're just going
to say i forgot my password like this
and in here let's just send off event
for that password
okay
so now if i press the command s button
to hot reload you can see i forgot my
password displayed here and we press it
and at the moment actually nothing is
happening it's probably because we
changed our main dart file and we
haven't done hot reload so sorry hot
restart so i do a hot restart now and i
say i forgot my password you can see we
end up in this screen that we just
developed and then you have the avail
ability to send a
um reminder email and if you say back to
login page then logout is sent and you
end up in here okay
so that is working now
um
now what we need to do also in a login
view dart in here so let's go to login
view dart
and have a look at how we're handling
this user not found at the moment and we
have just user not found but if you
think about it there is going to be
people from both apple and google who
will test your application when you send
it to app store and
uh google play store so just saying user
not found is a little bit
it's i don't want to say it's wrong but
it's just not fully
encompassing what could what the problem
could actually be
so
saying user not found is like the bare
minimum of what we could convey to our
user so let's just make that better by
having a little bit better
text in here so i'm just going to write
this text that i had from before so we
it's better just to say cannot find a
user with the entered credentials okay
just a little bit better message
as now that we're we've basically done
the forgot password where we're going
into the cleanup state so we're adding
some final ui touches to our application
to make it look better so as the caption
indicates let's go into login view and
add a padding in here you see we just
have a column and it kind of looks like
edge to edge it's not so professional so
let's just add a padding in here i'm
just going to say wrap with padding
and we're just going to say padding of
16 in here okay so it looks a little bit
nicer in my opinion at least looks
cleaner okay even if you're doing
website development you're
inherited um
for instance elements on the screen they
have like your user agent has some
padding already or margins built in to
inherited widgets it's our inherited
element so
um unless you go and change your css so
this is kind of us adding that um
padding in our elements in the flutter
application so
the next thing that we need to do in
here you can see in the login page at
the moment it's just on the top says
login and enter your email blah blah but
it doesn't actually give the user any
instructions you see here in the i
forgot my password we're giving the user
some instructions on what he or she has
to do but in the login page we're not so
let's go ahead and remedy that and just
add a text on top of the screen i'm
going to paste that text from what i had
before inside the children of this
column and we're just saying please log
into your account blah blah
and you'll see now that appear here just
makes it look a little bit nicer in my
opinion
and
we've already now fixed this and going
from the login view to our
forgot password we've already added that
in here as you can see so this element
at the bottom of the screen this caption
is already addressed we don't have to do
anything special about that
now let's go to
register view as you can see our
have you broken the register view not
registered yet i can see that that
button at the moment isn't working so
let's see what we've broken
event should register okay
and inside our off block
event should register i can see we
haven't even handled off event should
register so
that's
we need to definitely do that right now
so let's go to off block and
um
have a look at handling our um
i'm gonna remove this caption right now
because that's not what we're working on
right now so let's go to our off block
i'm going to maybe actually add that so
um
as a caption
so that it is clear
what we're working on right now okay so
let's go to our auth block and say on
this event
and let's just say event and emit
just like that
and what we're doing in here is to say
we're now emitting
constant off state registering
okay and there is no exception and there
is no loading so false just like that
okay and a comma here to get the
formatting working so now let's press
hot restart because remember you're
changing your auth block which is being
provided in your in to your entire
application in the main dart file so
main dart here
so you can see in here it's the
block provider that is basically
creating the off block so if you change
anything in your off block you may
actually have to do a hot restart okay
for those changes to take effect for app
for entire applications so not
registered yet pressing it goes to the
register view okay
so as the next point that we have to
handle here is to add some padding to
our register view
as you can see in here our register view
at the moment looks like this we have
the register button and already
registered button buttons right here but
we don't have any padding around our
register view so let's go ahead and take
care of that so i'm going to go to
register view here
and
let's go ahead then and wrap this column
that is
at the moment in here and just say wrap
it with padding as the caption at the
bottom of the screen says we're going to
add a padding of 16. so
you can see now we have some padding in
there and soon just like in the login
view we're going to add some text to the
top of the register view so what we need
to do is just to ensure that deleting
that their text inside this column is
actually pat it's and it's basically
sticking to the left side of the column
because by default all the components
that you place inside your column are
vertically aligned and no sorry they're
horizontally aligned in the main axis of
your
of your um
column so if you that's what i mean like
if the column what i mean is that the
column is expanding to the entire
space uh real state and then all the
components that you're placing inside
your column they're horizontally aligned
in inside the column so
that's actually a better way of probably
saying it so and what we need to do in
here let's just go and say uh inside the
column as you can see in the caption at
the bottom screen we're going to say
cross axis alignment
we're going to say cross axis alignment
start if i save this and go back to the
register viewer you're seeing this in
here basically like that and what we're
going to do then is to um
is to add a title to our column so i've
already added that before so let me
bring that up
so uh
i'm going to add a little title to the
first item inside the register view so
it looks like this but we also now that
we've done that i mean we want our text
field to be left aligned that's why we
added this cross access alignment but
we've kind of messed up the alignment of
our buttons in here so we need to kind
of wrap them inside centers so
what we could do is to inside you see we
have two elements in here but we don't
want to wrap both of them in their own
centers so what we could do is just to
say wrap um this
text button inside a column
then we put the other text button also
inside the column right here
and then we will wrap this column
inside a center so wrap this column then
inside a center just like that
so if you go back to our register view
now we have a nice little layout
displayed there
so we've taken care of that we've taken
care of the title of our application
and what we also need to do is to make
sure when we come to the register view
um
that we are auto focusing on our uh text
field in here
so let's go inside the effects if the
first text field and um
and right after auto correcting here
we're gonna say um
autofocus
true so when i press save in here and i
go to the register screen you can see
that the keyboard pops up automatically
auto focusing on the first email field
right there
okay now we also have a little problem
in here and that is
that we haven't
fixed our tests as you can see in here
implement send password reset and mock
auth provider
and throw i can see there's a spelling
error in the caption i'm going to fix
that right away um
like that
i apologize for that um
and that is here so let's go and fix our
test so i want you to please go to us
testing here and you'll see that we have
an error here telling us in mock auth
provider saying that we haven't
implemented the last function that we
just added to our off provider called
send password reset
so let's go in here and just ask it to
oops ask it to
create that missing override
and what we're going to do for this
exercise at the moment is just we're
gonna leave this as it is on implemented
error and i actually encourage you to go
and do an implementation for the send
password reset you may for instance do
some
mock and password reset do some future
uh delayed a weight on it and change
some states in your provider if you want
to you're more welcome to do that so you
could just take this as an exercise but
we're just going to leave it like this
for now but i highly encourage you to
actually write some tests for this as
well
so we've now done quite a lot of work
we've done quite a lot of reshuffling
things around what we could do is just
to have a look at the entire app and see
how it kind of looks like so i'm gonna
do a hot restart
and we end up in here you can see our
login screen works fine
and if we try to log in with a user that
doesn't exist in the application anymore
so i could just type any password and
say login and we get our updated screen
that says cannot find a user
then i can actually go and register that
user the text field is autofocus that we
fixed so foobar
who barbaz
register this user
and we can see that we get this verify
email we sent you an email verification
we also have to clean this view up soon
because i believe that this is not a
part of this a particular chapter at the
moment that we clean this up but we're
gonna we're gonna clean it up soon
um so the verification email should have
been sent now so if i go to my mail
application i'll just see if i can
somehow bring it up so
i can see
that
have i received any email from firebase
yes and that email is available here i
can bring it to the screen
as you can see there is a link on it so
i'm gonna tap this link and this will
then verify my user
if we then go to our
firebase so if i say console firebase if
we go to the console of our application
now we should see that user generated
here inside authentication
so that user is right here and is
verified user so we can just press the
restart button and log in with that user
so if i say
foo bar bas
log in and we see our dialog and there
are no notes so i'm just going to create
my first note in here
and it's sitting there thinking
and then i'm gonna say hello world all
right that's my first note gonna go out
let's go to the console again and to our
application and have a look at
our fire firestore database and make
sure that that note was actually created
and i can see that was actually created
here hello world with that user id nvic
if i go to authentication i can see nvic
is actually
and indeed that user so
it seems to be working we have quite a
bit of work still left we have worked
with the
with some margins we have worked with
icons app name etc before we can submit
it and these are things that we're going
to take care of in the coming chapters
but we've got we've come basically a
good bit forward
so we're almost there but not really
really there so
but no worries we're going to fix those
soon and let me do some screen
reshuffling in here and let's have a
look at the committing of our work which
is something that we usually do at the
end of every chapter so
i'm going to minimize scr cpy increase
the size of visual studio code so you
see my screen better let's go in here to
the terminal and have a look at this
shell in here and say git status
and and yes we have
a few files that are on track which are
new which is our forgot password view
which is new and password reset email
sent dialog which is new
and quite a lot of files that have been
updated in here so let's just say git
add all
and also git commit step 27 all right
hit status
and we have to push our changes also
so after we've done that let's also tag
as is tradition at the end of every
chapter we're going to tag this
and push our tags
and after doing that we can say git
status as you can see there's nothing to
commit in here and nothing to push
again as a tradition at the end of every
chapter we talk about what we need to
discuss in the coming chapter
so this is the exciting part at the
moment we've been working a lot with the
application code itself but we haven't
really done anything to make it ready
really for release the app store and the
play store google play store and there
are a lot of things that we have to do
such as screenshots we have to prepare
for
each respective store and we also have
to prepare the app icon the app name etc
so
lots of work to do and that's the kind
of thing that we're going to take care
of in the next chapter so i'll see you
there hello and welcome to chapter 45 of
the slatter course in previous chapters
we've been talking quite a bit about our
authentication and authentication block
and then in the previous chapter we made
our application a little bit more ready
for releasing in the app store and
google play store but we still have
quite a bit left and these are like some
of the final touches that we're gonna
put on our application before we can
release it in their respective app
stores
um so what we're gonna do specifically
in this chapter as you can see in the
caption at the bottom of the screen
we're gonna take care of our app icons
and the app name and i'm gonna take you
through the process which works very
well and has always worked for me so i'm
going to show you how to grab
free icons bring them into your
application and also be able to kind of
like automate that process you don't
have to generate the icons by hand
so to begin with we have to talk about
what app icons are so so far we've been
just kind of like running our
application and just looking at what is
inside the app itself we haven't really
have we haven't had the time to actually
look what's the application
how the application is represented from
the user's
perspective on the operating system so
if i bring up scr cpy in the middle of
the screen
and then i bring this application and
the um
all the apps up in this android phone
for instance this you can see is our
application right here so if i change
the screen and
a little bit here so you see better so
you can see our
notes application is right here and it
has a default icon so every application
on both android and ios and pretty much
in every operating system has its own
icon so flutter allows you or flutter
provides a default icon for all the
applications that you create with
flutter create so you have a default
icon that is displayed for your
application but
this is just a default flutter icon as
i'm mentioning so we need to have our
own icon that the operating system can
display to the user
in order to represent our application
amongst all the other applications that
are installed on that target operating
system
so that's for the icons and then what we
have to talk about is what splash
screens are so splash screen is this
little screen that the operating system
displays on the screen and as soon as
you open an application so i'm wondering
if there's any application for instance
here that i can
open up in order for us to see a splash
screen so let's for instance go here to
the clock application and as i saw here
let me just bring it up again so if i
kill the clock application
by going here and then i go to the clock
application again you can see that there
is a black screen just
displays instantaneously and then just
disappears that is the splash screen and
or in this case you could actually see
it's the lack of its flat screen because
there's no splash screen apparently for
the clock application and let's go to
calculator
and this application opens up so fast it
probably doesn't even have a splash
screen but what essentially his flash
screen is is a screen as its name
indicate that gets displayed to the user
just very fast while flutter is
loading its binary to display to the to
um the user so there are two stages for
flutter to actually show a splash screen
one is when the application binary is
being loaded by the operating system and
then there is another stage when the
flutter engine is being loaded to be
basically kicking off your applications
process basically but i'm not going to
go into too much details about that but
just know that splashbearing is a screen
that the operating system displays the
user while it's loading the application
so if for instance your application is
being loaded or is being displayed for
the first time on an android telephone
version that has very old hardware
because there are thousands and
thousands of android devices out there
then the operating system may actually
take a lot of time in order to load your
binary and that time it will and during
that time it will display a splash
screen so we're going to fix both the
app icon and a splash screen soon
so let's now talk about where you can
actually find some icons so if you're a
designer and if you're comfortable with
figma or sketch for instance then you
can go and design your own app icon
you're more welcome to do that i can i
feel free with figma i'm not a sketch
user but i can design my like icons in
figma but that's not what we're going to
do in this chapter we're actually going
to go to this website as i'm showing you
here stockio.com and grab some free
icons so
if i minimize scrcpy here and bring up a
safari window let's just say
stock io.com you can't see that right
now i'll bring it to the screen
like that and you can see you can hear
go to for instance icons and then
there's a search functionality where you
can search for the type of icons that
you're interested in these icons are not
really free sometimes they're actually
they need to be paid for however you can
also find um cheap or even free icons
that you can use in your application but
it's very important that you attribute
the author work the way they ask you to
do that and i'll talk about that soon
so for our application we're actually
going to grab this particular icon so
it's called stock io we're going to go
to free icon
in here
and say sticky
note file icon okay so that's the icon
we are going to use for our application
and and you can go ahead and do the same
thing i mean it's not that the app store
is gonna like google play store and apps
are not gonna set us like they're not
gonna stop you from releasing your
application just because your icon
is the same icon as someone else's app
so they're not gonna
basically check that really unless your
icon represents a very well-known app
for instance if you
add the facebook icon to your
application then the people who are
reviewing your application are going to
know that immediately and recognize it
and then they're going to flag it and
perhaps reject your application but this
is such a generic icon that i don't
think anybody is going to basically
have anything to say about it if someone
else has used this already in one of the
hundreds and thousands of applications
that are available in in those
respective stores so what we need to do
here go and say free download as an svg
so i just did that so let's go in here
and
have a look at that
excuse me
so i'm going to bring it up here and you
can see it's an svg and that's been
downloaded on my computer right now so
i'm gonna um
basically talk now a little bit about
attribution
so as you can see here in the
information that is provided here on the
screen i'm going to increase the size so
you see it better it says free for
personal and commercial use that's that
means even if your application is free
or paid for
in this in this flutter course we're
going to release our application as a
free application of course but if even
if it's for a commercial use you're
allowed to use this icon but it says
with attribution to stock io.com so
what we should do if we're a good
citizens of the internet land then when
you basically upload your application to
the app store and google play store as
i'll show you later we will actually
write a little sentence and attribute
the um stock io.com website and even
maybe say icon is provided by
stockion.com and even place the entire
url of that
icon um
inside our application description when
we submit it to the respective app store
so be very careful about this because
there are actually artists that are
creating these icons for you so
even if you
see that it's free you may be attempted
to just say yeah i forget about i'm just
gonna put it there i'm not gonna
attribute the author but if you think
about it it's just one line of text that
you're going to write in your
application description it's worth it
because someone has actually sat there
spent quite a lot of time designing this
icon so it's just
good
karma to make sure that we follow these
attributions apps that are provided in
the website where you download your
icons okay
so now we have this svg icon so if i
bring my finder here so we just have one
file in here but as you'll soon see when
we submit our application to app store
and play store google play store we have
to provide various icon sizes all right
so and
it's not that you have to provide the
various icon sizes to the app store but
when you build your application you
actually have to provide these different
icon sizes to the operating system for
instance if the user is loading your
application on a very old iphone without
a retina display which i highly doubt
now nowadays almost all ios devices have
a retina display
then that user with that phone that
phone particularly cannot display very
high resolution images so it needs to
grab a particular
app icon resolution however if you run
your
app for instance on an iphone
13 pro max then that device can actually
display a high resolution image so
using this svg file we have to create
and slice it up so that we have various
icon sizes to provide for various
operating systems and device
configurations
so that's what we're going to do but
we're not going to do that by hand we're
going to use a tool in here called app
icon dot co so let's go in app icon dot
co
and this is a great free tool that you
can use and you can just basically
drag your svg file in this
target and it will generate your icons
for you so let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to drag this svg in here just
like this
all right and you can see that i can
generate the icons for the destinations
that i'm interested in our application
doesn't support watch os at the moment
and we're not a mac os application so at
the moment we're just saying iphone and
ipad and for android okay
so let's just generate these icons and
if i go in here i can see that there was
a zip file generated in here so let's
just unzip this file and have a look at
it and you see that there's a folder
called app icons so
it has android app store assets etc in
here okay
so now that we have these icons
generated here as a caption indicates we
have to add them to our application so
how do we do that do we go ahead and
like
add these by hand no but there is
actually better way of doing this so
i'll explain it to you right now
there is a package called flutter
launcher icons that can take care of
this for you so instead of you having to
place these icons manually inside your
application binary or inside your
application source code for instance
visual studio code or android studio it
can do that for you so let's go to pub
dev
i'm getting rid of this dialog here as
well and let's search for flutter
launcher icons okay
and we found it right here and you can
see that it is provided by the flutter
community right there and there is
information on how you should actually
configure this and we'll get there soon
so
uh
but what we first need to do
uh is to
bring this into
our application so this uh
plugin
so
let's go to installing in here and
you'll see here that it says
dart pub and with flutter we want to do
this basically father pub at flutter
launcher icons okay so let's go ahead in
our application so i'm going to bring
our application in here and
let's go to terminal so let me bring
this up a little bit
and let's just paste that command in
here um boof
all right so that is just going to add
flutter launcher icons to our
application
and so that's the adding of it so if you
go to pop spec yaml now and have a look
at our yaml file you can see that
there's this flutter launcher icons
added right here okay then what we need
to do is to create some sort of a
configuration file for this plugin and
to understand how it should generate our
icons for us you can see if we go back
in here
you can see that there's some
information about that if you read the
readme file it actually asks you
actually to generate a file called
flutter launcher icons yaml and that's
exactly what we're going to do in here
so let's go to the root folder of our
application so if i
collapse every
folder in here so make sure that you're
in the root folder of your application
and then i'm just gonna say new file
and let's just add flutter launcher
icons okay
and in here they basically say add this
assets icon etc etc so
let me just bring this
here copy this information as it is
stated there and place it there but we
also have to add a new um
and basically key in here called remove
alpha ios and we have to set this to
true and this is a key that i don't know
if it's actually documented so let's
have a look at the documentation in here
let's see version scores change log
installing
it's not really documented unfortunately
but there may be inside the git
repository for this application like
there may be some good documentation to
be honest with you change log
examples um
flavors could there be anything in there
production
no unfortunately but i will just explain
what this key basically does what it
does is an ios
as an operating system it doesn't allow
alpha channel transparency channel on
its icons on its app icons so
what you need to do is to get rid of
that so when we generate our icons we're
going to tell this plugin that hey when
you're generating the ios icons remove
the alpha channel and for you designers
out there you already know what alpha
channel is okay
so it's just a transparency layer
all right so what we need to do now is
to grab our icon the downloaded icon and
place it inside assets icon icon.png
okay so as you can see in here let's see
if you have an assets folder and we
don't so let's go ahead and say new file
oops a new folder
and i'm going to say assets
and then we're gonna call it icon okay
just like that
and let's go then and bring that app
store png file that is right here and
just place it inside the folder that we
just created so it's a huge file okay
and that's okay
so now that we've done that and you'll
be wondering okay where why is it under
assets icon and that's because in this
launcher configuration we said that that
icon should be there you see icon png so
what we need to do now is just to rename
this file to icon.png
just to make sure that this
package can find it under assets icon
icon ph png as it's specified here okay
so in order to then generate your icons
you just have to run this for
this command right here so i'm gonna i'm
gonna go to terminal
let's see uh terminal is actually right
here it's ginormous
um let's go here terminals and i'm then
going to clean the terminal get rid of
the left hand side bar i'm going to say
flutter pump run flutter launcher icons
and main just like that
that is going to basically do its job
have a look at um the configuration and
then it's going to generate our icons
for us
so in order to test this we actually
need to make a clean build and this is a
little bit of a pain in the neck and
that's completely okay it's just because
we change something dramatic in our
application and then we need to just
make sure that we stop the running of
our application so i can see now this
particular application at the moment
isn't running in scrcpy so that's really
good
as you can note here this is the icon of
our application right now without us
having launched it again
so let's just do as the caption
indicates we're gonna do flutter clean
and after cleaning is done we're just
going to say flutter
pop get in order to grab all our
dependencies again
and i can see that you can't actually
see what i typed there but that's what i
typed flutter pup get as you can see
here
and it grabbed all the dependencies
again and what i'm going to do is just
going to go to main dart file in here
and
just run the application but before
doing that i'm just going to also make
sure that flutter select device has
selected the correct device which is my
android app and which is my android
phone and just gonna say run without
debugging
it could actually help if you removed
your application as well
so just to make sure that that
application is completely deleted from
the phone so it's completely gone now
and really all we have to do is just
right now wait for this gradle task to
complete its work so i'm just gonna let
it do its work and um
let's just wait for it
all right
now you can see that our application is
running on uh scr cpy which is an actual
real phone in here so if i now go back
here and bring up all the apps installed
on this device you can see we have this
application running right there my notes
and it has this little icon here and
this is another application that i've
had from before so i can just uninstall
that safely and we just go to our
application in here you can see it is as
we left it last time but the important
thing is that there is a new icon
basically provided here
so
that's really good now we've tested that
on android so the testing of android is
actually done so you don't need this
caption at the bottom of the screen i
should have brought up brought it up a
little bit earlier and what we need to
do is just to run our application on ios
as well so i'm going to stop the the
execution of the application on android
and i'm just going to say flutter select
device and iphone 13 pro which is a
simulator and then i'm just gonna say
run and this is also gonna perhaps take
some time because usually i run my
applications on the android telephone as
you've seen with scrcpy i usually don't
run with an ios simulator or a device
when i'm developing with flutter
and but it is always good practice to do
that so now it's doing the xcode build
and let's just wait for it to finish
okay and now we can see that our
application is also running on ios so
what we can do in here is just to send
the app to the background and then you
can see that we have our my notes
application right here and the icon that
we basically created for our app so that
seems to be working as well
what we need to talk about now is our
app name and as you can see in the
caption at the bottom of the screen
since we need to update the app name
it's not so nice as it is now and right
now it's just saying my notes with a
lowercase and and capital m and all in
one word so it's not as it should be so
let's go ahead and fix this and the way
to do that is that you have to do it in
two places one for ios and one for
android so we're going to take care of
ios first so in visual studio code i'm
going to jump into a file called info
key list and this is the info p list is
like basically an ios applications and
kind of configuration place which you
can configure a few things for
application like permissions etc and if
you go to this uh file ios runner slash
info p list so let's go in there and
then there is a key in here called core
foundation bundle name so
let's see if you can find a bundle name
cf bundle name at the moment it says my
notes in here so we need to fix this
just to call it basically my notes like
this
okay
and let's see if there's any other place
in here we can also see that there is a
bundle display name which we may also
have to fix so let's just call it my
this
and to be honest with you we don't maybe
actually have to change the bundle name
i would say maybe changing the bundle
name is not so good so
let's not do the bundle name actually
i'm going to change the caption and just
call it changing the bundle display name
because i would say a bundle name and
bundle display name are two completely
different things the bundle name is like
the binary name of the application and
the bundled display name is what the
user sees on the screen so let's not do
the bundle name and let's just change
the bundle display name in here and just
call it my notes okay
so after doing that we could try to
stop the application in here and then
run it again
um
it may take effect it depends kind of on
how flutter is gonna trigger these
changes with xcode build and how xcode
build is going to interpret our changes
sometimes
it might actually be necessary for you
to do another clean
and then run the application again on
that target platform so that's just a
bit unfortunate when you change like
huge changes when you make you changes
to the applications structure
and i could see now that my notes was
actually taking the fed effect right now
so we don't have to do any flutter clean
so that's really good
then what we need to do also is to
update the app name on android and we do
that by going to android app src main
and we could just do that right now so
let's go to android manifest xml
and you can see here is android app src
main i'm going to go in there and then
i'm going to find this
key in here android label and just
change it to my notes all right
so let's just do that and then i'm going
to go here just to a flutter select
device run it on my android phone then
i'm just going to stop the ios execution
and just go to run run without debugging
so that you can try to run the
application on this android phone so if
everything works as expected then we
should have our mynotes application
right here with the correct uh
icon and then we should also have the
correct label alright so let's just send
this to the background
let's go in here and have a look at our
application you can see now it says my
notes the right icon and also um yeah
the application is running as it should
and if you go back to our ios
application then we can see the name is
also correct and the right icon
so we could actually say that we've
already tested things on ios they seem
to be working so if i bring up the
simulator the app is working as it
should
and
we don't have any crashes the icon is
correct and the label is correct and on
android if we bring up scrcpy again you
can see that the
icon is correct and also the name of the
application is correct
so
we've done what we said that we're going
to do in this chapter we talked about
icons and we also talked about what
splash screens are in preparation for
the next chapter and it's usually the um
what we do in the and at the end of
every chapter we talk about what we need
to discuss in the chapter that's coming
so what we need to do in the chapter
that is coming is to prepare ourselves
for creating splash screens you now know
what splash screens are but in the next
chapter we're gonna go and create them
and
we're gonna add them to our application
so grab some refreshments if you want to
do
and
i'll see you in the next chapter hello
and welcome to chapter 46 of the
slaughter course um if you follow the
chapters up to this point
chronologically you'll know that we've
done a lot of preparation and we're
actually about to start preparing our
app to be submitted to the app store and
google play store but before doing that
now that we fixed our icons and
our application name for both android
and ios we need to fix something called
a splash screen so
and we talked briefly about splash
screens and what they actually mean in
the mobile world for instance in both
android os and ios and ipad os for that
matter but for those of you who missed
the previous chapter
a splash screen is a screen that is
displayed to the user when they open
your application from a cold
boots basically meaning that your
application hasn't been running for
instance in the background in that
operating system and while the
application binary is being loaded to
the screen and the experience is being
loaded to the screen
um then the host operating system in
this case android and ios will have to
display something to the user while
they're waiting for the experience to be
loaded
so in native applications for instance
if you're creating a native
application with um
coupling for ios sorry kotlin for
android and swift or swift ui for ios
then um in that case there is there is
only one stage of loading for
application in that
you submit your binary to apple and then
or
um to google play store and then the
host operating system just loads your
binary and then that um your main user
interface is displayed to the user so
it's just one stage
in flutter however there are two stages
of loading your application one is
the your application binary in itself
being loaded and the second stage is for
the flutter experience to actually be
loaded inside your application since
flutter is its own sdk basically
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a splash screen that gets
displayed to the user while our
application binary is being presented to
the user
so let's have a little look at a the
official documentation for splash
screens
and i'm going to bring the
screen up here and increase the size
perhaps a little bit so like this
so you see here
as it is explaining here first and you
have your
android for instance operating system in
here and you tap on your application
icon and then it goes through a series
of steps in order to land on your
application's um
main interface and here there's a great
documentation basically for splash
screens which i recommend everybody
who wants to submit their application to
ios app store and google play so to read
this thoroughly because there's great
pieces of information here even if you
are just following for instance my
advice in this chapter but it is still a
good practice
to go ahead and read about this
so um
before we actually go and start
designing our splash screen
i also have to mention something that
[Applause]
this chapter is quite i mean you need in
order for you to be able to go through
the chapter you will unfortunately need
to have a macintosh so because we're
actually going to play a little bit with
our
um ios splash screen and for that you
need to have xcode but i'll talk soon
about that as you'll see
so how do we go about creating a splash
screen so
i mean there are so many different ways
of doing this and
if if you're a developer from before you
probably are not so comfortable you're
not this kind of like a unicorn
developer you might not be
a so-called unicorn developer as a
developer who's also comfortable with
designing
or you might you might only be a
designer and you've started this course
and you've come to this point so you may
actually be comfortable with a tool like
figma
so um
depending on your background you may or
may not be comfortable with designing so
i've basically taken the liberty of
using a design tool a free design tool
called figma
and for this chapter which you can
access freely with for instance a google
account or an apple
apple id
or you could just create a normal free
account on figma.com
but i don't make the assumption that you
know anything about designing and for
that what we're going to do is we're
going to create a very very very simple
splash screen in figma
assuming that the person is watching
this course has no information about
figma or designing previously okay
so
let's have a look um
now that we talked about figma let's
have a look
at storyboard on ios
so um what we can do in here is to bring
our application to the screen so i'll
bring up our
app in here increase the size a little
bit so you see it better
and what we can do is to bring up
terminal in here so get rid of a little
bit of distraction in here so
let's see
so if you say good status we have a lot
of stuff that we've done but we haven't
committed them so that's fine let those
be there we're going to commit them soon
okay
so in your application what i need you
to do is to
have a look at
your ios application so there is
something in the ios application
generated by the flutter
template when we created our our
template from the absolute beginning of
this course
and there is a file a specific file
called a launch i believe it's called
launch screen dot storyboard if you're
not comfortable with ios development
like native ios development from before
i can just explain you that a storyboard
file is
a file that apple designated for um
developers to be able to visually design
their application and then write the
code for it later and apple's decided
that for specifically the launch screen
for instance that gets displayed to the
user there should be a a dedicated um
storyboard file for that so
we're gonna go ahead and launch xcode
on this macintosh in order to manipulate
that storyboard file but before we do
that i'm just going to go ahead and open
the root folder of our application
then i'm going to go and let me also
change the screen layout a little bit so
you see
things better
then inside this ios folder so in the
root folder of your application go to
ios and then you can see two files in
here runner xcode proj and runner xc
workspace and dependent on your settings
on your macintosh you may or may not be
able to see
the
extensions of these files i i've i've
done so in my macintosh that i can
always see
file extensions because it's important
for me so if you're not seeing the
extensions you just have to trust on the
icon so one of these files has this
bluish icon which says project here and
the other one is a workspace i need you
to basically double click
on this workspace in order to open it
okay
so let's go ahead and open this
workspace inside xcode
and let's then go have a look at this
launch screen inside this runner folder
so
if i collapse everything inside you will
see that you have your runner and which
is the flutter templates created
workspace
inside there we have another runner and
in that runner folder then you'll have
this launch screen
so
we can then have a look at this launch
screen and see how it is created
and you can literally
click in here
in order to expand the contents of this
view controller to have a look at the
internals of this launch screen and a
good trick is if you want to expand you
can see here you have to expand this and
then you have to expand this and expand
this
if you don't want to expand one step at
a time you can always hold down the
option key or the alt key and then click
on this little arrow and that expands
the entire chain for you and if you want
to collapse the entire chain you can
press down alt and then click and then
collapses the entire change so
let's let's expand the entire chain and
then in here you'll see that there is a
view and then a launch image image view
which at the moment is pointing to a
file called launch image which doesn't
exist because if you go to our assets in
here you'll see that launch image is
just empty at the moment okay so there
is no launch image meaning there is no
splash screen okay
so
we're gonna manipulate this file a
little bit as you'll soon see so let me
just
keep xcode running okay
so that was the basics of that launch
screen storyboard and
as you see at the caption on on the
caption at the bottom of the screen this
is an unfortunate unfortunate thing that
um
that apple
isn't as open in my eyes at least as
many other companies like microsoft and
google
in that if you want to for instance do
native ios development and have xcode in
order to open your project and run your
project for instance then you'll have to
have a macintosh because xcode isn't
available on other platforms and it's
very unfortunate i mean
it's it's nothing to really be proud of
i would say i'm a native ios developer
and i'm actually ashamed of the fact
that xcode the tool that i use on a
daily basis is only available on a
macintosh because i might personally for
instance
like to write my code ios code on ubuntu
or fedora
or some of you may actually prefer
windows but let's not go there let's
just say that you'll unfortunately need
macintosh in order to be able to
manipulate that
um launch screen as storyboard file and
for those of you who don't have a
macintosh you'll need to contact perhaps
somebody in your network who does have
access to a macintosh and ask them to
manipulate the storyboard file for you
and add your icons as you'll soon see
how and then send that storyboard file
back to you
so
that's an
unfortunate problem
um
so what we need to do is to actually get
to the
roots of what we need to work on in this
chapter and that is creating a splash
screen okay so as i mentioned in the
beginning of this chapter i'm gonna rely
on a free tool called figma
so let's go ahead let me see if i can do
some re
reshuffling on this screen
and close a tab in here i'm gonna bring
up my browser
gonna minimize our application and bring
up my browser right here so i need you
to please visit a website called
figma.com
and in figma.com then you will have the
ability to create your design files all
right
so i'm not gonna show you actually how
to register for figma because that is
very easy so you can just perhaps if i
for instance go to and bring up a
completely new
tab in here and say figma.com where i'm
not logged in you can just say sign up
and as you'll soon see here you can
continue with google or use an email
address of your choice in order to sign
up
for figma and as i mentioned figma is
free until to a certain point
and you can you can for instance um
work with your uh
normal design files in figma without
having to think about actually
paying for a subscription but if you
want to do advanced work for instance if
you want to do a lot of sharing of your
work with other team members etc then
you will need to
pay for figma
so
after you've registered your account in
figma what i need you to do please is
just to go and click on new design file
okay so i'm going to increase the size
in here and just say new design file
all right so it's created a new design
file here for us and as you'll see as
you'll see in the bottom of the screen
in here um i wonder if i actually have
to bring my face to the right because
i'm blocked by that
so i hadn't noticed that so um
so what you'll need to do is to create a
container here on figma
maybe this is a better screen um
yeah set up maybe this is better okay so
what we need to do in here is to create
a container that is at
1284 by
2778 and i didn't i didn't like make up
this number
this is the size of a screen for an
iphone 13 pro max so
if you're not a designer you may not
notice but when you're designing things
you always have to create like your
design so that it it scales to various
sizes this was not a problem back in
2007 or 2008 when we only had one iphone
and just a handful of android devices
but nowadays you have to kind of like
create a template in for instance figma
and then ensure that it is scalable for
different sizes but we're not going to
focus on that right now all we're going
to do is just to create one
splash screen and then inside our ios
app and android app we're just going to
make sure that it scales okay so let's
just target one device at the moment and
in here i need you to go in here and
actually here sorry about that and
create a rectangle
after creating a rectangle we're going
to go in here and set the width to what
i've
specified down there 18284
i can see my keyboard and the height is
going to be 2778
okay so it's a huge rectangle
as you can see here okay so
that's our rectangle and what we need to
do is to kind of give this a background
color now as you've seen so far and if
you follow the chapters chronologically
for this course you'll know that i
basically use a very very
soft theme in visual studio code for
uh coding and i absolutely love this
it's the preference you may like a light
team i like a dark team such as tokyo
night and tokyo night is a visual studio
code theme that is open source and you
can actually grab its
colors from
github so what i'm going to do in here
is just to make sure that the background
color of our splash screens actually
painted with that color okay so let's go
and search for tokyo night
in github and you'll end up in this
website github.com and kia tokyo night
vs code theme so if you don't have this
link and if you couldn't be bothered
writing this name you could just google
and so i'm just gonna go to google and
say tokyo night theme okay and you'll
end up with the github link so you can
just click on it all right so i'm gonna
go down here in this um theme and i'm
going to grab this beautiful editor
background storm
color from here okay
um actually either we could use storm or
night i'm gonna choose storm and just
see how it looks like so grab this code
please
the rgb code for uh tokyo knight and
let's go to figma into our rectangle and
just paste it in fill
so that created a nice little background
color for us okay so we could just live
with this at the moment
then what we need to do is i like to
basically create some sort of a gradient
in this background color so it's not so
bland as it is right now so what i'm
gonna do is just to go to effects in
here and then say that we have actually
no not effects it's probably in fill
let's go and fill press the plus button
and in here just click on this little uh
space right there
and let's just say that um
you know what actually i would really
like to change the screen layout a
little bit so you see my figma screen
better so i'm gonna hide this caption
and let's see
and see if i can change the caption
length
like this
so that it is smaller
and hence i can change the screen layout
with my screen with my face still
visible so i think this is a little bit
better okay after doing this fill so we
added a fill effect in here using this
plus icon
and go and tap on this um little icon
next to fill you see here clicking on it
you can then say that you want for
instance a
linear should we create a radial maybe
or a linear gradient let's see
let's create a linear gradient okay
then this as you can see is a gradient
that at the moment is going from black
to
transparent with zero percent in here so
let's make this black point as well
transparent
like this
zero and we're gonna in both these cases
set the background color as the starting
point and the ending point so click on
the starting point change this color to
our um
tokenite background color and here as
well so that's that okay then in the
middle somewhere we're gonna create a
point and give it a hundred percent uh
transparency and let's see how it looks
like so
in here can we not have three points
yeah figma just went a little bit
ballistic on us but that's okay
so in here we have that color in here we
have that color
so so the start and the end have to be
transparent with that color that we've
chosen and let's go in in the middle and
just kind of change the color to red and
you can see that it gets created here
without a problem
and then what we're going to do for the
middle we're going to go and create
grab this particular color here as you
can see it's kind of like a light very
soft light blue starts with 7d so it's
7dcff
and i'm going to go back to the figma
design and in here
change the middle color to that
just like this okay so it kind of
creates a nice little effect for us in
the middle kind of a
nice
gradient okay
so after doing that let's go to our
downloads and grab our icon so i'm going
to go here to
downloads and if you remember we had
this
sticky note svg file and figma is great
with stuff like this so let's just grab
svg right in the
middle okay and that's our sticky note
right here okay
so let's see what we can actually do
should we use the svg or should we use
maybe our app icons
it's probably better to use actually the
app icon so revert this change please so
let's not use this svg let's go to our
app icons that we extracted in the
previous chapter and let's grab a
rasterize png which is this app store
icon and bring it right here okay so it
actually is a nice size i'm going to use
these built-in layout guides in figma as
you can see it tells me where the center
is so i'm just going to place our icon
right there and as you can see it
actually blends really well with that
background linear gradient that we
created so it's a it's a subtle effect
so you can see that the linear gradient
is a little bit visible
and if you disable that linear gradient
with this icon it's
it's very bland so without that linear
gradient it's our splash screen doesn't
look so well so you can also play a
little bit with the transparency of the
entire thing like 100 and i feel like um
this is just
crazy so maybe 20 was actually pretty
good
i don't know where i went
so here let's go back here and say 20
okay
as it was so now we have a really good
um
base for our splash screen so what we
need to do now in order to download this
splash screen you need to select those
two layers so on my macintosh i'm just
going to hold down the shift key and
click on this icon for instance and then
click on the next one in order to select
both where i think you could actually
no you can't select like that so you
need to basically hold down the shift
key and select both layers
then press
command g on a macintosh or ctrl g on
linux and windows in order to group
these two layers together okay so now
it's a group and i'm just going to call
it
splash screens just like that it doesn't
have to be called like that splash
screen but i just call it so okay
so what we need to do is to grab this
splash screen in three flavors so
normal like um in normal ios development
you have to support three different
resolutions for your assets usually
some developers are
not as bothered with
supporting older devices
so they only support for instance the
resolution of 2x and 3x
and if this doesn't make sense to you i
will just explain what this actually
means
um
modern devices
on ios at least they're called at their
screen and they're called retina devices
and it's just a term created by apple um
many many years back
and where they said basically they
doubled the amount of pixels that a
device can display on the screen but
they held the aspect ratio as it was so
if in a little square in an old device
the device could display four pixels
then the new devices could display eight
pixels so they doubled the amount of
pixels per square feet
i don't know how you want to say it and
they call it retina and then they added
they said every
every developer needs to provide an
image for the old devices and we call it
1x
as in
scale to 1
and the new devices will have 2x
then newer iphone devices came out they
had more modern retina displays and even
more pixels packed into the same
space so they said now those devices are
able to display eight times more pixels
than the original ones so
it's basically gonna be um one x two x
and three x
so um i think it's eight times more
is that i don't know
so it's 1x2x and 3x that we have to
support so let's go in here
um
let me see if i can shuffle things
around so you see better um maybe like
this so let's go in here in figma at the
bottom of the screen you see this export
button so i'm going to press that export
so i'm going to press that export button
actually three times as you can see in
here so we have the first one is a png
make sure that they're all png files and
the first one has no suffix second one
has two x and the third one has three x
that's exactly what we need okay
so
after doing that what we're gonna do is
to say export splash screen just like
that
and that's gonna do its processing so it
may actually take some time depending on
our internet connection as well and then
we downloaded this zip file so our work
in this file is basically done and this
is the contents of that zip file as you
can see splash screen png and they're
all the same but their sizes are quite
different you can see the first one is
604 kilobytes the second one is 1.4
megabytes and the third one is 2.5
megabytes okay
so after doing that let's now remove
safari or your web browser from from the
screen
and we need to basically go into our
source code now so i'm going to keep
this window here do some reshuffling on
the screen
and then i'm gonna bring our
let's see i'm gonna bring our uh
application to the to the screen like
this
okay and actually we don't need the
application sorry about that we kind of
need xcode in here so let me bring up
xcode
but let's bring xcode to the screen and
what we need now is to go to our assets
in here run our assets and we have our
launch image right there so what we need
to do is to grab these images one at a
time and bring them in here okay so and
they can be called splash screen that's
not a problem xcode will do the mapping
for us so as long as this thing in here
is called launch image then we're
good to go
so as a caption any case we're now going
to go and bring these images in here so
we have three images you can see in here
and we have three placeholders in here
that we have to drag and drop our images
into so let's begin by splash screen png
and bring it to 1x
let's bring our splash screen 2x into 2x
and 3x into 3x okay
and just like that
so
that part is now done but we're not
really done designing this splash screen
as such for the ios app so
let's go to the launch screen storyboard
file in here as you'll see it doesn't
look so well
so
we need to find this launch image that
is displayed in here and you can see at
the moment its constraints are like
very very wrong so it just thinks that
if you go into this tab it thinks that
this image is one two eight four by two
seven seven eight
but we don't want that okay we want this
image to be as big as the screen but we
also want it to
fix the aspect ratio of the image so
that it always fills the entire contents
of the screen even if that means the
image goes a little bit outside the
outside the boundaries of the screen
okay so that the launch screen looks
great on all ios devices
so what you need to do here is just a
little bit of a work on ios side so you
need to go in and select your launch
image in this tab in here which is your
dimensions the size inspector as as it
is called in xcode go and say that the x
is zero and y is also zero so that kind
of like make sure that your image starts
right there then let's just zoom out a
little bit and go manually and drag this
a little bit so that it fits the screen
so i'm going to drag this point let's
see if i can do that with my trackpad or
maybe i should use my
mouse and it's it's like playing a
little bit with me just because this
launch image at the moment has some
constraints so let's go and actually
remove these constraints so i'm going to
remove this horizontal constraint by
pressing the backspace button on it or
if you're on windows and linux you have
to press the delete button on your
keyboard so now i've removed those
constraints so i should be able to
freely size this hopefully let's see
and it's not letting me size this but
that's okay so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to have a look at this view
and see its size i can see that view is
896 then i'm gonna go to my launch image
and say okay your height is also 896. so
that's going to ensure that the height
of my launch image is the exact same
height as the view then i'm going to
have a look at the views with is four
one four and i'm gonna go to the launch
image and say you're also four
four one four okay
so now the image container actually
looks good however this launch image it
now has hard-coded values hard-coded
width and hard-coded height
it's x and y and y are quite fine but
what we need to do is to create some
constraints for it and constraints are
literally i mean we're not going to go
into native ios development at this
moment so you need to kind of have some
knowledge about this yourself and if you
don't i'm just going to tell you just
quickly how we create these constraints
so what we need to do is to click on our
launch image and then drag
and hold down the control button on your
keyboard okay
so
click
hold down control and drag from launch
image into the view
like that
then this menu appears on the screen and
then hold down the shift key on your
computer on your macintosh and say you
want an equal width
equal height
and also you want to see leading space
and you want to say
what else do we want
yeah
that's fine for now i would say i mean
ideally what we want is for this screen
to be in the center as well so maybe we
could just say center horizontal and
center vertical so check these four
items as you're holding down the shift
button and then you can let go of the
shift button and then just click here
anywhere on the screen to dismiss of
that
so now you can see xcode is also happy
with the constraints that we created
then what we need to do is just to tell
this image to scale
according to its width and height so
let's go into this tab which is called
let's see what this tab is actually
called
attribute inspector and inside this
scaling here actually
it's not scale really i believe it
should be content mode in here and let's
just say it is aspect fit okay
so it keeps the aspect ratio of the
original image but it also ensures that
it's like yeah it's fitting on the
screen for now okay
so let's leave it like this
all right so let's then go ahead and
actually see if this looks okay so what
we could do is to write in xcode let's
just say yeah
let's run on ios 13 pro which i believe
is the simulator and that i have already
in here
and from
from xcode itself we can press the run
button to have a look at how this
actually looks like and while this build
process is going you can also go to your
simulator here and say file
and open simulator and i'm just going to
choose another simulator as well such as
iphone 8 plus okay it is just good idea
usually to test your splash screen and
the functionality of your application on
as many devices and simulator as you can
i mean i actually prefer to test on real
devices but right now
it is quite
difficult for me to bring so many test
devices on the screen so i'm just going
to use a simulator to test the splash
screen okay
so now what we're doing is just to
compile our application for iphone 13
pro which is a simulator we've been
using so far when it came to for
instance um
testing our application so let's move
this to the background because this is
not really our application this is our
application so let's bring it here
and let's
just give some time to xcode to do
the work that it needs in order to build
our application for this simulator and
also install it and run it so that we
can have a look a little bit at
the splash screen so i'm just going to
be
waiting until that process is done
all right now our application is running
on a simulator called iphone 13 pro so
what we need to do is to actually kill
the running of the application because
after the application is launched we're
not going to see the launch screen even
if you for instance send the application
to the background with command shift h
that sends the application to home and
bring it back up there is no launch
screen remember launch screen for an
application is only displayed when the
application is completely dead and it's
cold booting so in order to send in
order to basically kill the application
what you could do is either press the
stop button here on xcode which
basically kills the debug
process and
and also kills the application so now
you can actually click on the
application in your home screen and
bring it to the foreground and as you
saw that was the little splash screen
that we saw on the screen so i'm gonna
kill the app and bring it back up again
and that's our splash screen so seems to
be actually looking fine on iphone 13
pro let's now change the target in here
and change it to our iphone 8 plus
which is the other simulator that i
brought up here
and the reasoning for that is that
iphone 8 plus is still a major player in
the market a lot of people have iphone 8
plus and the screen is fabulous it is a
great phone that people are still using
so and the huge difference between
iphone 8 plus and iphone 13 pro is that
iphone 8 plus has no notch so it doesn't
have um the notch that you can see in
here on an iphone 13 pro so and it has a
home button so that's a little bit of a
thing that we have to think about that
you need to test your application on
multiple devices and now i'm going to
kill the application oops i don't
actually know what i did so
let's go in here and i'm going to kill
the debug process on iphone 8 plus as
well and run it again and let me just
delete this old app from here so we so
we don't get confused and
if you run the application did you just
see it momentarily that the application
that the splash screen doesn't look so
good it's not doing so well so if i run
it again with do you see the spacing on
the right and left if you pause the
video you will see it
that is because we have a little bit of
problem with our aspect ratio in here
because you remember in this launch emit
launch image we said aspect fit what we
need to do is just to say aspect fill
and aspect fill what it does it tries to
keep it it doesn't try it keeps the
aspect ratio but it always makes sure
that the image is that is at least as
big as its container so having done that
let's run the application again on
iphone 8 plus
with that change in mind and let's see
how the application looks like
now it looked a lot better so there was
no empty space to the right and left i'm
gonna kill the application like this
send it up bring it up
and let's see oh it's because my debug
debug process i just killed my debug
process so let's kill it again
like this let's see
if i c if i can manage to do that kill
the application
and open it
and now i can see that this splash
screen is actually looking good on
iphone 8 plus as well
great now that things are working fine
on ios we need to focus on android so
let me bring up the caption for the next
section that we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about android slash
screens here i'll also try to open this
url
so let me bring it here
so you'll see that there is official
documentation about creating splash
screens for android as well on
developerandroid.com
guide topics ui splash
slash um
splash dash screen
and
um here there is a lot of information
that you can have a look at and like
even animations as you can see in here
what splash screens mean to android
applications and that you can even
animate them etc etc so i suggest that
you actually read the documentation for
splash screens on android to get a
better understanding of the differences
between ios splash screens and android
splash screens it's always good to know
i like the underlying implementation and
how it actually works under the hood
if you're a flutter developer you don't
necessarily have to only focus on
flutter but you since you're deploying
your application compatible with for
instance mac os linux windows and
android it's always good to know in my
opinion
how it works under the hood so
if you want to have a look at this
please go ahead and read the
documentation on how it works and now
let's go to this a little beauty
of a link which is on stack overflow
which which is one of my favorite
websites to find
um
solutions that i can't even think of the
answers to sorry the problems that i
can't find the answers to so let's go
ahead and have a look at this url in
here which will explain to you the
different resolutions that we have to
provide for our splash screen for an
android device and you saw it from our
figma design in here
it's gonna load now
excuse me um
so here you saw that when we exported
our
oh this sticky note shouldn't be there i
don't know why it was added there so i'm
just going to remove it and i hope that
we actually didn't create our
splash screen with that in we could
double check that by bringing up xcode
and have it looking have a look at our
assets
and just have a look at these images
showing finder
excuse me i'm going to bring it up and i
can see that little sticky note wasn't
in our splash screen so that's really
good it was just probably a mistake
from my side so
that's great so as you saw for ios we
exported these assets in here three two
one x
with these suffixes so two x four two x
three x for three x and nothing for the
normal um
splash screen on one x devices but on
android there's a lot more that we have
to export so i'll open that url in here
that you can you'll also see and you'll
see that these are the various um
resolutions that we have to export for
our splice screen on android we're not
in our application supporting ldb ldpi
in here so we'll we're going to go and
export mdpi hdpi xhdpi and etc etc so
let's go ahead now in your figma design
right there select your splash screen
from the left hand side and go go ahead
please and remove all these exports
that we've created earlier okay so what
we need to do now is to make sure that
we're conforming to these sizes for mdpi
for instance and we're going to
basically select the splash screen and
say export
and let's in here see
that okay these are the sizes so 1x
let's just say we don't want any suffix
and i've already prepared something like
that before so let me just show you how
it should look like
and i'm going to select this splash here
and you can see this is pretty much how
you should create it so one x and we say
mdpi as it was displayed in here mdpi
you see and then we say one and a half x
is hdpi and xhdpi etc etc okay so let's
go ahead and do something similar in our
splash screen in here so one x and as
you could as you could see in the one
that i preferred here one x was mdpi so
let's go ahead and say a suffix is mdpi
like that
i'll create another export in here and
we're in this case we need hdpi which is
one and a half x so let's select this
and say one and a half x and we say hdpi
like that
and then we go for the next one which is
xhdpi so let's go and press the
plus button in here and say 2x is a x
hdpi
and then we go to the next level which
is xxhdpi
so
let's press the plus button and say
uh and this needs to be
x x hdpi okay
so we're gonna say xx hdpi
and last but not least we have triplex
hdpi which is
four x the resolution so let's say xxx
a plus button triplex hdpi
and in here this should be 4x okay so
now oops i didn't want to create this
drop shadow so
that's how yours should also look like
with all these uh various resolutions in
here
okay
so now what i need you to do please is
just to go ahead so make sure that your
slash screen is selected on the left
hand side and then just go and export
all of these so let's just press the
export button
so that's going to take its time and
calculate basically all these different
resolutions prepare the pngs for us and
it's going to pack them into beautiful
zip file and then
it's going to download that packed file
for us so depending on your connection
speed this could take some time and the
result i can see is an untitled 2 zip
file uh
of about 10 megabytes so there we go
so let me
double click on this file in order to
unpack it and i'm going to open the
folder here for you so you can also see
as you can see splash screen
it's all there so they're all looking
very similar to each other but they have
very different sizes as you can see
though so the xxx hdpi has the size of
almost four megabytes whereas the mdpi
is only 600 kilobytes so
now we got our images perfect so what we
need to do is um
we're going to basically
call them splash screens and then place
them inside various
um
mipmaps folder in our android
application so let me bring up visual
studio code in here let me see where
i've placed my visual studio code right
there okay
and if you then ex
go into exploration a little bit here
you can see we have an ios folder so let
me just make the size a little bit
bigger
excuse me
and we have an android folder in here so
if you go to android and then app src
main and then res and you'll see that
you have these mipmap folders hdpi mdpi
and all those one two three four five
folders that we need for our five assets
in here okay so let's go ahead and
actually name this file in here and let
me close this little folder that i have
at the bottom of the screen as well so
okay so um we start with mdpi in here
let's just call it splash okay slash png
and i'm just gonna go to this mdpi
folder here and i can see i have a
launcher icon an ic launcher so let's
just drag this into mip map mdpi if i
can
and mid map mdpi there it is so the mdp
i want is done
now
i'm going to delete it from here so now
we have hdpi then i'm going to call it
splash again remember it's hdpi so i'm
going to drag and drop it into the hdpi
folder so it's called png there as well
then i'm going to delete it from here
then we have the xhdpi so i'm going to
call it splash again
and remember xhdpi so let's go and drag
it there great then delete it from here
then we have
xxhdpi so call it splash again
and bring it into xx folder in here
and i can see it's right there splash
okay
and last but not least we have the
triple x hdpi and we're going to call it
slash again and then let's go in here
and bring it right there
great so now you should actually see one
two
three
four
and five images that we have exported
and placed inside our android folder so
then i can delete the last one safely
so now that we've done that we need to
actually tell our android application to
use those splash screens so what we need
to do is to look for android window
background inside our application i'm
going to close all these open tabs and
i'm going to search for android window
background just like that okay
so you'll find four of them but only two
of them are actually interesting for us
so what we need to do is actually i'm
going to go to my styles as well here so
as you can see here is using a drawable
but we're not using a drawable a
drawable is something that for instance
if you look for launch background let's
go in here you see these um
fine launch background actually is there
a drawable called launch oh we don't
have it right now okay anyways so i'm
gonna search for um
android window background as it was our
mission
so let's go in here and find that window
background and here as you can see it
says drawable launch background and this
file is android app src main res values
styles xml so that's the first one okay
that's this drawable so i need you in
here to change this to mipmap
and in here just say splash which is the
name of our file that we created okay so
that's the first um occurrence of this
android window background and then we're
going to go in here as well which is in
android app src main res values knight
styles xml and call this mipmap
like that
and in here we also say splash perfect
so we've changed those
so what we need to do now is to actually
test our changes on android as well so
i'm going to close all those tabs as you
saw and let's just go to main dart file
just to have a dart file open
and then i'm going to stop the running
of this application because i don't
really know i think it's actually
running the application on um the iphone
simulator and then i'm going to say
command shift p on a macintosh or ctrl
shift p in windows and linux if you're
on visual studio code and then say
flutter select device as you can see in
here and then i'm going to choose my
android phone okay and as you know from
the previous
chapters i actually prefer to run my
applications real phones and then run
and then run without debugging
and this is gonna
basically kick start our gradle build
processing here and while that is
ongoing i'll go and bring um scr cpy to
the screen so here it is and
i can see
nothing actually what happened to our
build
i think our build somehow crashed so
let's go and build again and see what
happens
debug console and
okay i can see it says there is a
problem and let's see another expected
caller reference bot got raw string mid
map splash okay so let's have a look at
what we actually did with this mid map
splash i can see i've actually written
incorrectly i've written me map so that
could that could explain it it's a
mid-map so if you've done the same
mistake as me in one place please just
correct this so it's mipmap
all right so
fine okay fair enough and let's now try
to run the application again and see if
it can compile this time
so it says
it got a raw string again and it's now
did i really type it in correctly did i
write mimi map
this is unbelievable um if i've actually
done that so
so no i i think i've actually written it
in two places incorrectly so
map
all right
it would be very comical if i made a
mistake again while trying to fix my
previous mistakes
so let's see now if the android build is
gonna go through successfully so i'll
just wait here until that task is done
okay it's built successfully i was just
gonna go grab some coffee so
and it's connecting now so that actually
went really fast i would say gradle
builds in here are surprisingly fast
when running with flutter for instance
compared to the ios xcode build system
so i'm going to bring up scrcpy in here
and i can see the application running
without a problem but we didn't actually
see our splash screen so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
stop the
processing here which kills the
application and then i'm gonna find our
application here and then open it and
then i can see our beautiful splash
screen on the screen when the
application starts so that's also
working as expected no problems at all
and remember we've done quite a lot of
work now we've done like icons from the
previous chapters and we've also worked
on our splash screen so
there's lots that we've done but we
haven't really committed any of these
because the work wasn't complete
however
now that we have um
both icons and splash screens on both
ios and android i think it's time that
we do as we usually do at the end of
every chapter is to commit our work and
make sure that we're not going to lose
it
so i'm going to do some reshuffling on
the screen right here and i'm going to
increase the size here as well so i'm
going to go to terminal then like this
and let's then have a look at the status
and you can see that we've done a lot of
work so
there are many files that have been
changed as you can see in here modified
modified
a tremendous amount of work so
let's just say get at all and then let's
commit all this work as
is it step 28 yes step 28 okay
so if you look at our logs so we have
step 27 and then we have step 28 as well
so i'm gonna push all these changes and
this push is actually quite a big push
because we have a lot of resources that
we're pushing to github so or wherever
you're hosting your git repository it
could be bitbucket or somewhere else but
depending on your connection and the
ability of your host to receive these
files this operation could actually take
some time so and after we've done that
let's also tag our work at step 28
like that and push our tags
all right so if i say now git tag we
should have 26
27 and 28 line up right there so perfect
and we should have no status right now
awesome
as it's tradition after our tagging and
committing everything at the end of
every chapter we'll talk about what we
need to discuss in the chapter that is
to come and
um
i can't believe we're actually getting
to this point in this course it is such
a huge moment both both for me and i
hope it is for you as well because we
are actually going to submit our ios
application to the app store
so without further ado if you want to
get some refreshments please do and i'll
see you in the next chapter
hello and welcome to chapter 47 of the
slatter course
uh we've been waiting for this moment
for a very long time now at least i have
so that we have been developing our
application using block we've been doing
a lot of work with widgets we've
prepared splash screens icons etc etc
we've even got our hands dirty with
figma a task that maybe many of you
hadn't done before so
what is left now well we're gonna send
our application to the ios app store and
it gives me really a lot of pressure
pleasure to actually announce that that
we're gonna do this so
what do we need to do in order to be
able to interact with the app store and
also
in order to be able to create your
application of course you you're going
to need to have a macintosh and that is
as i've mentioned an unfortunate fact
when you're dealing with ios development
but if you don't have a macintosh you
can always contact a friend or maybe you
use a service on the internet that can
for instance take your source code and
build your application for you i don't
know if those services exist however
let's just accept the fact the
unfortunate fact that you'll need to
have a macintosh in order to build your
application and send it to the ios app
store
so
what do we actually need you see when
you create your application for um for
apple you need to bundle it up inside a
file which is pretty much just a zip
file but its extension is called ipa
and this zip file in essence contains
your entire application bundle all the
resources and all the
signed binaries from your side and then
you'll just need to submit it to apple
and
then this submission is going to go to
something called app store connect and
um
we're going to now talk about app store
connect actually and what that is so you
see
when when you're developing your flutter
application for instance and you're
talking with firebase then inside of
your code you're talking with the
firebase sdk but on the backend side of
firebase then there's an entire console
so there's in the console.firebase
google.com i think it's called
or if you just google it and say
firebase console you'll get to that
point and
app store connect
is
the firebase console for ios developers
so it is where you basically manage your
applications
the reviews that are submitted to your
applications you can respond to those
reviews so it's like the back end
um
is kind of like a front end for app
store's back-end
you could say so it's your portal
basically to to the app store as a
developer
and google also has something similar
which is the google developer console
excuse
me so what we need to do now in order to
be able to continue we need to actually
create our applications on the app store
connect so what i'm going to do in here
is i'm going to bring up app store
connect and i've already logged in with
my developer account
and let's go in here as you can see
these are some of the apps that i'd
submitted to apple previously
if i can increase the size of this let's
see if it works yep
all right
so what we need to do is in order to be
able to submit our application if we
haven't done that before for this
particular application which we haven't
we need to create an application here on
app store connect okay so please go to
appstoreconnect.apple.com
and then you'll be presented with a
screen that asks you okay what do you
want to do with app store connect and it
kind of looks like this my apps app
analytics etc etc
and this is actually
i'm assuming that you have admin access
to app store connect because apps are
connect like many other
frontends it has
permission it's like permission based so
if you're for instance working with a
company and that company has invited you
to their own app store connect account
and depending on the permissions that
they set for you you may or may not have
access to either one or all the apps so
it is also app-based the permission so
like and i can invite you to my app
store connect and only give you access
for instance to this application and
only give you a very limited access or
admin access okay
so if you don't have access to this app
sections because you're invited as
um as a user to someone else's app store
connect account and they haven't given
you the access to access their
application so you need to ask them for
permission basically to increase the
permission level for you
so let's go ahead and press this plus
button and this is in here we're going
to say new app and in here it's going to
ask you okay what kind of app is it it's
an ios app it's not a mac os like we
haven't really worked on a native mac os
application although
users
now with
m1 processors on macintosh with
macintosh which are arm based they can
actually install ios applications as
you'll soon see so this application that
we're developing flutter we didn't
actually create a macintosh target for
it but even though it's an ios
application you can still install it
with test flight or later when it's
actually released on the ios app store
you can install it with the mac app
store on your macintosh so it's
absolutely lovely
okay so here one you need to do in the
name field
you need to find a unique name in the
entire app store there are millions of
applications on the i'm actually making
up this statistic i don't know if it's
like hundreds of thousands of
applications or millions but let's just
let's just say millions because easier
to say
all these applications are in the app
store you have to find a unique name for
your application and remember you can't
use reserved words so if you look in
here
if i cancel this if you look in here
this is not an accepted application name
so i just i've prepared this in here
just to demonstrate it for you that
if you use for instance a name like
firebase things like that
probably apple is going to reject your
application and definitely google is not
even going to allow you to go to the
google play store with a name
with a part of your application name
being a reserved word like a product
such as firebase so
you have to find a unique name that is
not reserved so let's just say ios and
what should we call this i mean in our
application we call it now my notes
i'm pretty sure if you say my notes that
name is already taken
so let's say
my
awesome notes something like that
as you can see it says it is the name
that will appear in the app store okay
my awesome notes
and in here in this box the primary
language we're going to choose english
and we're going to choose us because we
didn't really focus on
separating
our language like how we actually
interact with the user with our strings
in the application to make sure that
it's like british english or us english
so let's just go with the international
us english in here
and in this box you're going to be asked
to actually choose your bundle
identifier and app store connect has
then after you log in with app store
connect it's going to hook into the
developer account for this user that you
logged in with and it's going to pull
all your bundle identifiers into the app
store connect so you don't have to type
it by hand so let's go find our my notes
application as you can see in here it's
as epic salty my notes and for you it
may be something else okay
so i chose that and then sku is a unique
id for your app that is not visible on
the app store so this is mainly for you
sku is kind of like
it kind of comes from like um
old school when you had a normal
physical store and your products had
kind of like an identifier so this is an
identifier for you it may appear some
places like when you're extracting some
reports from apple to see okay how many
unique users do i have how many unique
installs do i have etc
so this sku is mainly for you it's an
identifier so you could just go with
something that makes sense to you and in
here i'm just gonna say zero one zero
one zero one
or
this and then one one one one
just making things up okay
and user access in here you can say you
you can limit which user see this app in
the app store connect if you select full
access all your users will have access
to the app so this is like you limiting
who can in your app store connect
account who can have access to this
application and since i don't have any
guest users in my private company's
account i'm just gonna go with full
access but if you're working with like
if you're if you're the account owner
and then you have some other people
invited to app store connect that don't
want that shouldn't get access to this
account you could just go in here and
basically say limit the access to this
application to these accounts but i'm
just going to go with full access okay
i'm going to say create and in here is
the place that you may actually get a
problem with the name of the application
so let's just try it out and see if my
awesome notes is some name that somebody
else has taken and we'll get to know
that soon
and from from the looks of it it seems
like that my awesome notes was such a
lame name that nobody has taken so
so that's great for us so um now we've
created the application and um
that part is basically done
so as you can see in here the first
thing that you have to enter in this
screen let me actually increase the size
and let me change the screen layout a
little bit here okay
so the first thing that we see on the
screen here is that uh there's a version
information and also there's app
previews and screenshots and this is the
place that we're gonna upload our
screenshots to the app store
as you can see at the bottom of the
screen it's very important that you take
your screenshots first on an iphone 13
pro max because that is
the iphone with a six and a half inch
display and you may be tempted to just
try to take your screenshots on an
iphone 13 pro but if you do that then
you'll understand after uploading them
you'll get an error from app store
connect saying that the resolution isn't
according to what is expected so what we
need to do here is to go to our iphone
um simulator so and i have quite a few
of them here
so this is our iphone 13 pro
this is our iphone 8 plus
and also we have our iphone 13 pro max
so now our responsibility is to actually
take the screenshots on this simulator
however you'll notice that we have a
little problem in here
well problem problem but for taking
screenshots this is a little bit of a
problem in that we have this debug
manner here that i am that flutter
creates by default so if i zoom in a
little bit here you'll see that it's
it's just saying debug right here and we
need to make sure that we remove that
before taking our screenshots so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to go back
to our source code so
let's go in here
and you can see at the moment the
application's running on iphone 8 plus
which is the simulator to the left hand
side so in order to remove that debug
banner what you'll have to do is to go
to your main um dart file as you can see
and go to the main function where you've
created the material application right
after the title or even before you can
just say banner which is debug show
check mode banner and set that parameter
to false and then i'm just going to do a
hot reload actually hot restart we have
to do so
oh i'm not even running it so let's just
go flutter select device 8 plus and then
i'm going to say run without debugging
so you need to ensure that you remove
that um debug show checked mode banner
and i started not remove it you have to
remove the banner by setting this
parameter to false and now it's going to
basically run the application on iphone
8 plus and it's going to show us the
results so this debug banner is going to
go away
after doing that when we see that it's
working on iphone 8 plus for instance
then we're going to do the same thing do
a flutter select device and run the
application on iphone 13 pro max so
this process depending on your machine
depending on your settings etc it could
take a while so i'll just wait here and
do this
now it's running okay that's eight plus
that's great so now that's done now i'm
going to close this and stop the debug
process and say flutter select device
and choose iphone 13 from max
and do the same thing run without
debugging okay
and then
again depending on the machine that
you're running this command on this
process could take anywhere between a
few seconds to maybe even a minute or
even maybe more
so
i'm just gonna wait here for this
process to go through and um
while that is actually happening you'll
also need to know that you need to take
your screenshots on iphone 13 pro max
and iphone 8 plus in order to be able to
cover all the required screenshots for
app store connect so since we don't need
iphone 13 pro i'm just going to minimize
it right now into the taskbar and here
is iphone 13 pro max
so let's go ahead in here and take some
screenshots so i'm going to minimize
iphone 8 plus as well so we have this in
focus so what i'm going to do in here is
i'm going to go to this login field and
at the moment as you can see i can type
in this field because this is a
simulator but i don't see the keyboard
but in real life when users actually
download your application and run it on
their iphones they're gonna see a
keyboard so it is a lot more realistic
if we bring the software keyboard as
well on the screen so to do that on your
macintosh we'll just have to do command
k for keyboard and that will just bring
up the keyboard just like this so
what i'm going to do since i don't like
this carrot that at the moment is
blinking right there what
i'm going to do is just wait until that
carrot appears and just take a
screenshot of this iphone 13 pro max
simulator and the way to take a
screenshot on a macintosh on an iphone
simulator is to press command s as in
screenshot or save okay
so i'm just going to wait for this care
to go away
and sorry about that i'll just go also
here in desktop and remove everything
that was created already
so
here's the simulator and here's the
desktop then i'll wait for the care
and it went away i took a screenshot so
let's go ahead and do the same thing in
forgot password screen for instance
and i'm just going to wait for care to
go away took a screenshot
then let's go back to the login screen
and then to the register
and right here as the care disappears
i'm going to take a screenshot as well
so this is going to be our third
screenshot okay so we have a screenshot
of the login screen the register screen
and
the verify
or was it verified
i forgot my password sorry okay so now
i'm going to log in with a user that
already exists in the application so
that we can take a screenshot of the
main interface of the application as
well so i'm going to take a screenshot
of this with command s on my macintosh
and maybe for the fifth screenshot we're
also gonna take one from where you're in
the screen and editing your notes with
the keyboard up as well okay gonna wait
for the chara to go away and i just took
a screenshot right there as well so now
you should end up with five screenshots
for your application so if you have a
look at them they should kind of look
like this this this this this and ensure
that also you don't have that debug
manner by removing the debug show check
mode banner and after doing that if
you're already running a debug session
on your simulator for instance you have
to do a hot restart remember hot reload
is not going to take it's not going to
take the code in your main function into
effect all right so now we have five
screenshots in here so i'm going to go
back to app store connect and let's then
tap here or click here and view all
sizes in media manager okay
and let's go to choose file in here and
then choose all these screenshots and
i'm just gonna say upload
all right so now in here you have
basically the chance to reorder these
screenshots so i think i'm gonna put
maybe the login screen first then i'm
gonna go to the register and then forgot
password and i'm gonna then put the main
interface of the application
here and then the actual new node screen
okay so you can see at the moment when
uploading the six and a half inch
display screenshots the five and five
and eight inch display screen is also
using the six and a half
inch display screenshots so they're the
same screenshots so you don't have to
upload them again however then you have
this five and a half inch display and
which you also have to upload your
screenshots for and that is what we need
the iphone 8 plus for so
we i'm just going to minimize this and
then i'm going to bring up iphone 8 plus
to the screen
and we're going to do the exact same
process here so bring up the keyboard as
the carrot goes away take a screenshot
of login
sorry i'm going to go to
forgot password screen
carrot goes away take a screenshot then
i'm going to go to a register screen
carrot goes away screenshot and in the
login screen i'm going to log in with a
user that already exists in the system
if i can spell
and now
it's just
beach balling on me so
um
at oh
it's my keyboard by the way i can't see
the keyboard so i can see it's been
switched to unfortunately swedish so i'm
just gonna switch to
english here english
and
it's not helping me really so let's see
if it can switch to english
please
english
for some reason it's still showing the
swedish stuff in here and i don't really
know why so i'm just going to say
gmail.com and foo barbados okay
he's i mean
an iphone simulator is also software so
it could be buggy okay so then i'm gonna
take
let's see what screenshots we've taken
so three screenshots so far and let's go
to the main ui of the application take
another one with command s as i've
mentioned before and let's go here as
well into
oh is this screenshot gonna go away
soon hopefully
go away please
it's not gonna go away
please go away okay i think iphone 8
plus is having some problems so what i'm
gonna do is i'm just going to close it
and then say open simulator and let's go
to 8 plus and i can see after i close
the 8 plus simulator it actually saved
the screenshot so that's great all we
have to do is just to go back to our
application and right here in the screen
as the keyboard is displayed on the
screen after the carrot has disappeared
i'm going to take a screenshot
i'm not sure if i actually
did it at the right time without the
carrot on the screen so let's have a
look
please go away okay
so this is the screenshot so now we have
five screenshots on iphone 8 plus as
well so i'm gonna basically delete these
screenshots that we took from the iphone
13 pro max right there and let's go to
the five and a half inch display section
here in app store connect and say choose
file and i'm then going to choose all
those screenshots that we took from
iphone 8 plus and reorder them so let's
say log in first then we have register
forgot password and then main interface
of the application and then new nodes
and this is exactly in line with what
we've done in here so it's just a good
idea usually to make sure that your
screenshots are lined up in the same
order for different devices okay so now
you can see all those
three other screens screen types are
using the iphone 8
plus i think simulators screenshots so
okay
yes iphone 8 plus so now we've uploaded
those so as you can see more screenshots
are already there now so iphone 8 plus
is also uploaded and we're done
so what we need to do now is to bring up
the ipad pro 12 inch simulator as well
so i'm going to go here to this
simulator and say file open simulator
and then say ipad pro
as you can see we have to bring ipad pro
12 inch so i'm just gonna click on it
like that
let's go to um visual studio code and
say select device and then i'm gonna
choose that ipad pro as it is there and
then i'm going to stop the debug process
on the iphone 13 pro max and then say
run it on the ipad pro
and if you're lucky then this process is
actually going to go quite fast because
the application binary has already been
compiled and it should pretty much be
the same application
running on an ipad pro 12
0.9 inches so
again depending on your machine this
process could take anywhere between a
few seconds to a few minutes even
and
let's see here so let's go in here and
you can see the first section in app
store connect for ipad is asking you to
upload
for ipad pro third gen which doesn't
necessarily have to be third gen any
ipad pro of 12 and a nine inch display
is going to suffice
so here's our application it this screen
is obviously ginormous so i'm gonna go
here bring up the keyboard and
take a screenshot and then go to forgot
my password take a screenshot then go to
back to login and in the register screen
take a screenshot all where the carrot
has disappeared let's just double check
this and i'm going to remove the iphone
8 plus screenshot so now we have three
on the ipad pro no carrot no carrot no
carrot and let's go now to the login
screen and i'm going to log in with an
existing user in here okay foo barbat
login and now you can see the main
interface of the application let's take
a screenshot of it and then go to the
first note bring the keyboard up like
this and without the carrot take a
screenshot i actually think i
i um captured the carrot unfortunately
in this last screenshot and i can see a
little bit of glimpse of it there so i'm
gonna delete that and
i think i did it actually again to take
a screenshot basically
of the same screen with the carrot
so let's see
if the ipad's going to help us soon
where's the screenshot there
i can see the carrot again a little bit
so this is a tough one now all right i
think i got it this time
so let's just wait for the screenshot to
appear here
okay
and there is no carrot so that's great
so now we have basically our screenshots
for ipad
12 and a nine inch display let's go in
here and say choose file and i'm gonna
select all the screenshots for that ipad
and put them in order so i'm just going
to say the login screen first then
register then forgot password the main
interface of the application and then
the note screen okay so as you can see
the 11 inch display is using the 12 and
a 9 inch display so that's really great
however the ipad pro here the second gen
to 12.9 inch display um is
is i mean these it's not using this 12
and a 9 inch display of this ipad so
what could we do here can we go in here
and say choose file and upload the same
screenshots again and it seems like we
can so that's not a problem let's just
reuse the same because it's the same
screen size so it's a bit strange that i
app store connect is not automatically
using this 12 inch
ipad screenshots for also this 12 and a
9 inch display even though they're the
same so i'm going to bring login to the
left then i'm going to bring register
here for god password like that and then
the notes and then the new note so now
you can see all your screens are now set
all the snap all this screenshots are
set for both iphone and ipad
so after uploading all our screenshots
then we can actually go and set the
basic information
of our application so
so let's go in here inside our app
information
okay
and you can see here there is a note and
that is called
sorry there's a name inside the app
information section then we have the
name of our application okay and then
the subtitle as you can see it says the
subtitle will be reviewed before it's
made available on the app store
unfortunately it doesn't tell you so
much information but every application
can have a short subtitle up to 30k up
to and including 30 characters so when
people search for my awesome notes for
instance in app store then they can
actually see both the name of the
application and a short subtitle so
let's say store
and store
your notes securely with an asterisk at
the end okay
so that's already set i can see so um
and then we could then after making
these changes
the app store connect expects you to
press the save button so that's also
good now we've set that
so let's go here in this section and go
to content rights and then set up
content rights information click on it
so it says apps that continue or access
third-party content must have all the
necessary rights to that content or be
otherwise permitted to use it under the
laws of each app store country or region
so we don't have third-party content
like we're not actually displaying any
videos that's coming from a third party
service so here we can just say no it
doesn't contain show or access third
party content
and after pressing the down button we
can also press the save button just to
ensure that everything is as saved
so what we need to do in here also um
let's see here
a privacy we also have and then we have
set age rating across all platforms so
let's go ahead and do that and say as
you can see here it says select the
level of frequency for each content
description that best describes your
application so we don't have any
violence so we say no realistic violence
none
uh prolonged graphic or sadistic
realistic violence i don't even wanna i
don't even to say say these things out
loud to be honest with you but what you
have to do is just to say none to all of
these because we don't have any like
medical information alcohol related
stuff so let's just say none to all of
these
and uh
contests and we don't have that either
so let's just say next does your app
contain unrestricted web access it
doesn't does your app contain instance
of gambling no and then we're saying
next and you can say our
age
rate rating result is that people of age
four plus can use the application and
here
make sure that your app is not made for
kids because remember applications that
are made for kids that have to actually
conform to specific standards in order
to make sure that eight kids of age four
plus are actually safe in the
application so
um what we could do let's see in here if
your app rates 12 plus or lower and you
believe it contents may not be suitable
for children under 17 you can manually
set the age rating to 17 plus so i'm not
sure about this to be honest with you
but i'm just going to leave it blank at
the moment and press the down button
okay and then we can press the save
button right here
so the next thing that we need to talk
about now is something called a support
url and support url is actually very
important and that actually appears i
believe in app
let's see
is it in
app information i believe
i think it is somewhere around here
ratings and reviews app privacy
pricing and availability
we haven't really come there yet but i
believe we have to submit that anyway
somewhere and it is here as you can see
so support url is actually very very
important as you can see marketing url
is not
optional sorry marketing url is optional
support url isn't a support url it's
basically a url
that needs to be hosted on your website
that users of your application if they
have any problem with it then they can
go to the support url and get some more
information about that okay
so i have previously created a support
url for one of my other applications in
my website so let's just say pixel sc
and then we're going to say support
chords library text okay and as you can
see here it's a little text document and
says if you have any questions about
this app you can drop us a line at
support pixel
dot
so you need to just ensure that you have
a support document that you can um
place in a website and then you can send
your users to that okay so
let's now go ahead and create a support
document so what i'm going to do in here
i'm just going to bring up literally
text edit on my macintosh you can bring
your um favorite hex editor um um
actually my tech favorite text editor is
visual studio code but in this case it's
just a simple text document so i'm just
going to use um normal text edit on
macintosh even if you're linux for
instance you can just use vim and create
or vi you can create a simple document
and let's i'm just going to basically
copy this and paste it in here and i say
contact support and thank you for using
my awesome
notes
because that's the name of our
application right it is my awesome notes
so i'm going to save this document and
i'm just going to say in here let's call
it
my awesome
notes txt and i'm going to save it on
desktop save all right
did it not save it
it is a little bit strange that it
didn't save it so
let me go back to this text now it saved
it
yeah it is right here okay so this is a
document now text file simple and i'm
going to go to my website control panel
as you can see here there's a support
folder
so i'm going to go into the support
folder and as you can see i already have
four text files in this pixelity se
website and i'm just going to
hopefully be able to drag a file in
there or maybe even upload so i'm going
to drag this file boom
and i can see it has uploaded now
and
seems to be it to be honest
so let me just go back and see i'm my
awesomenotes text file right there and
i'm then going to go in here and see
it's actually uploaded my
awesome notes
txt
and i can actually see it is uploaded
and it's there so
if you don't have a website which you
should if you're developing applications
for ios and android or even if you're
developing any applications and putting
it out for customers you should have
your own website and they're like very
cheap ways of grabbing
a website with cheap hosting i don't
want to go and like
sponsor various services and i'm even
not even gonna name what i'm using but
you can google that or
just search online for a cheap hosting
and creating a website of your own okay
but since this is the outside that's
outside the scope of this course i'm not
going to talk so much about that okay so
now we have this my awesome notes and
what we need to do
is to go ahead and add this support url
so i'm going to copy it here and go to
app store connect and in the support url
i'm just gonna save it there i'm gonna
press the save button okay
so
that's that and we also need to make
sure that we add some other information
in here promotional text description and
also keywords and etc okay so
these things are very important and we
need to make sure that we fill these out
so um let's see actually here okay
so in the promotional text let's just
enter in some information here as you
can see this commercial text lets you
inform your app store visitors of any
current app features without requiring
an updated submission okay so let's just
say
use
my awesome notes
in order to securely
store your notes in the cloud
all right and description and this app
sim this free app allows you
to
store your notes securely on the cloud
and
um
and that's it i mean they're very
similar to each other but that's okay
too
and for the keywords in here you have to
enter i think up to
it doesn't really say how many yes 100
characters you have and you have to like
comma separate your keywords in here so
i'm just going to say and notes and
secure
wow
and make sure you don't have to actually
have um
let's see boom
i don't think you have to have space
between them and i'm just going to leave
it like a notes secure cloud okay these
are my keywords so
i'm going to save this and remember
we're in here in the ios prepare for
submission section
so that's also done
and our app version is right there
copyright we can just say 2022 pixelity
uh
a b
all rights
reserved
okay these are just big words don't
worry about it
and um
and that is pretty much it so
um
i don't think we need to do so much more
to be honest with you in here
and uh we don't even have to have the
signing required for now
and
let's see and also need to go to contact
information in here so let's say
vandal
and my
last name
and then i'm going to enter some
fake phone number right now
something like that and here's my
support at pixelity
and like that
no signing required
and here where we have the version
release as you can see it says this app
version can be automatically released
right after it has been approved so
there you have a few
abilities to
how you want to actually release your
application so after you send your
binary to apple you can choose for apple
to either automatically release this
version
to all your users in the app store or
you can say manually release this
version meaning that after your
application has been
accepted by apple and approved by apple
you can go manually press the release
button wherever whenever it suits you
best
or you can say automatically release
this version after app review no earlier
now so you can set a date for it but
we're gonna say manually release this
version okay
and after all of this i'm just gonna
save this information right there and
let's now go to app privacy so this is
also very important to remember to do
because
i don't think
um
that we have actually
yeah i actually believe here now that
i can see that i've prepared some
information about this in the upcoming
chapter so
we're going to take care of privacy
policy in the next chapter so but know
that it exists right there and we have
to fix it soon
so then what we need to do is to
actually make a build for apple because
this is like the most important part and
and you need to make sure that you
followed like the first chapters of this
course where i talked about preparing
our application for ios there is a
chapter in the beginning of this course
where we actually talk about creating
our certificates and profiles and all of
that for
for ios distribution so i'm assuming
you've already gone through that so we
don't have to take care of that now all
right so let's go now to our application
in xcode let's see if i can bring up
xcode
it is somewhere around here
so there is our application and i'm just
going to go into runner and have a look
at signing and capabilities and release
and i can see that there is absolutely
no problem with this production
certificate and profile so what we need
to do in here to make a release for app
store is just to have a look at our
runner and here change the target to for
instance any ios device
and then we go to product and then we
say archive so
this archiving is then in turn gonna
create an ipa file for us and as i
mentioned in the beginning of this
chapter and this is the ipa file that
we're going to submit to apple
and
xcode is going to help you a lot with
that
i'm not sure if i'm a fan of that to be
honest with you i think xcode hides a
lot of details and usually i'm used to
like doing things in the command line
and doing things simply from visual
studio code for instance
but it is still a good thing that xcode
is going to help you submit your
application because
in the previous versions of xcode like
many many years ago xcode couldn't do
this so you had a separate application
to actually upload your ipa files to app
and that in itself was also quite
a
i wouldn't say a negative body was
something that you have to go through
so
it is a plus and a minus that xcode is
going to take care of all of these in my
opinion at least so
i'm just going to wait here for xcode to
do its
work and it is very possible that if
this is the first time that you're
archiving your application with the
certificates
that you
basically created in the beginning of
this course it's very possible that
when the time comes for xcode to
actually sign your binary and all its
other related libraries
it's possible that your macintosh is
going to ask you
for the password to this certificate and
actually it's going to ask you for the
password to the keychain
in which on your computer this
certificate is stored so this is usually
the login keychain so if i go to
keychain access in here you'll see that
i have my login keychain and i have
certificates in here as you can see
distribution so
this is the sort that i'm at the moment
using for duplication and um after
assigning this as you can see it's
archiving right hasn't really signed
things it's very possible that my
macintosh is going to ask me for the
password to that keychain so
it's very close now to
finishing the archiving process so
excuse me
so let's see basically how it goes after
after doing that after actually creating
our application ipa file we're going to
submit it to apple and that app is going
to be displayed then first inside here
in the build section of your
applications
store connect
view
so let's see if we get this password for
signing as i've mentioned here
at the bottom of the screen so 4660
or 70 files out of 5039 files to
compile and
creating our binary so it's very very
close let's just see if it can succeed
in doing that
and i can hear my macintosh um
and fans going full speed right now and
that's usually something you don't hear
on the latest uh
max or macbook pros because they're
usually so silent like the fan almost
never kicks in
but this is apparently such a heavy
process for this macintosh to perform
the faster googling full speed so
let's see if it succeeds
all right and here is where we're seeing
that dialogue that i was talking about
as you can see it says code sign wants
to sign using your van.hawa nippor in
your keychain to allow this enter the
login keychains password so it has
nothing to do with your certificate it's
just actually has everything to do with
your certificate but the password itself
is the login keychains password so
it's usually your computer's password so
i'm just going to enter that
and then i'm going to say always allow
all right so
after doing that hopefully xcode is not
going to bother me with this password
again however i know in some older
versions of xcode
it doesn't really understand when you
say always allow so when it comes to
signing your application you may have to
enter your
password up to like 20 times depending
on how many libraries your application
depends on so
i remember this vividly when i was
working at a company and a tester i was
telling that tester how to
compile an archive an application for
ios and we both thought that he's
entering his password for his
certificate incorrectly so and here now
we got
module shareplus not found and
what could that be because shareplus is
basically something that we're using in
our application
as
and it's continuing to archive even
though it it says that something's
failed so all right so now we got an
issue here with pods runner framework
and this could seem i mean i'm actually
quite glad that we're getting these
errors and that could some and be
because we haven't done a proper pod
install so what i'm gonna do is go to
visual studio code here and in the
terminal then let me actually change the
screen layout a little bit so you see
what i'm doing
so i'm gonna bring this up so you see
better what i'm doing and i'm going to
go to the ios folder
here
okay and then in here you could just say
pod d integrate
basically pod the integrate it's going
to remove all your ios dependencies from
your workspace and then you could just
say pawn install okay
and this is gonna reinstall all your
dependencies from scratch so
let's see and i can see share plus is
actually installed now so it's
generating the pods project
and
great so that seems to be fine so let's
go in here and see if we can
uh do a clean so i'm gonna go to debug
sra product clean build folder and let's
see if we can make a fresh build and
this could actually take some time
because now we've really
uh cleaned the build art artifact so
it's gonna basically start the archiving
process from absolute beginning so
i'm just gonna be quiet for a while and
let us do its work and let's see if the
archiving process succeeds
okay so here's the result of actually
archiving our application again and
we're seeing the exact same problem now
after doing a podly integrate and also
doing a completely new pod install so
we're seeing the exact same problem with
share plus say module share plus not
found and this could be a problem with
how we've done for instance our
um
pub get
and to be honest with you i could cut
this out of this whole video but i'm so
so glad that we're seeing these problems
because
archiving an ios application and simply
it's
not always going to go fine even just
doing the same thing for android it's
not always going to go fine and
if i cut this out of this video you you
will be thinking that everything is
going fine for me but things are not
working for you and then you'll start
blaming yourself but i really want to
keep these stuff in this course so you
see that well a person like me trying to
tell you how to do things also needs to
understand himself how and why these
things are going wrong so
in my guess in this case since we've
already done a pod install it would be
to actually go and clear the
build folder for our entire flutter
application and also do a
flutter pop get from scratch so
let's go ahead in our flutter
application in here and at the bottom
i'm just going to say fluffer clean
and that's going to clean the artifacts
for ios and android
okay
and then you're going to get a lot of
errors in your application because then
it doesn't understand anything so we
then say flutter pop get
all right
so that's gonna do its work and get all
your dependencies from scratch basically
and install them in your application
all right then what i'm gonna do in here
is to
yeah we could just leave it like that
now and go back to our xcode and then
try to archive the application from
scratch let's see let's see if this time
it goes a little bit better and
hopefully it shouldn't take so much time
this time but you never know with xcode
and
with ios development it has its own
antiques so let's just wait and see
after doing a pop get if this process is
going to go through or not so after
xcode has compiled the application again
i could see the same problems as as we
had before so meaning that our pod the
integrate and flutter clean really
didn't have so much effect on the
application itself now since i've been
doing ios development for a very long
time i still have some tools in my in my
belt that i can drag out and use
and one of the first things i would use
as a software engineer and an ios
developer is just to first have a look
at
our deployment ios version and here
we're supporting ios 9 and it's very
well possible that this
sharing capability that is built into
the plugin that we're dragging into our
application isn't compatible with this
ios version so first i'm going to bump
this to ios 13
at the moment at the their ios 13 14 and
50 are very popular so there are the
latest versions of ios at the time of
recording this um course so first i'm
going to do that
the next thing that i'm going to do is
to from our project in here so i'm
having a look here as you can see i'm in
the ios folder of this notes project so
let's go in there
then the first thing i'm going to do is
to perhaps remove the um i wonder if i
should actually remove the pod file as
well
maybe let's just remove the podfile.lock
and remove also all the pots from the
project okay so then i'm gonna do
fluster clean in here
that removed really all the pots from
the project
and then after undoing that i'm going to
have actually a look at our pot file to
have a look at all our ios dependencies
and see how they look like so i'm going
to stop the execution of the program and
then i'm going to open a file called pod
file and this is where all your ios
dependencies basically are stored as you
can see the platform is ios 13. so it
was strange that our deployment target
was ios 9 so this could be a potential
source of problem
and after doing that then we have our
pod file and yeah this this looks fine
as it is so
um let's then go after into the terminal
and after flats are clean let's just say
flop
flutter pop get
which is going to redrag
our dependencies into our flutter
project and ios project for instance
then and we can then go back i'm
actually going to kill xcode and open
the ios folder and open the
project workspace again and i can see
here at the moment the pods aren't
really installed so let's go and do the
installation of pods ourselves so i'm
going to say pod install this is going
to install all the dependencies and
let's have a look in here and say what
it is talking about
cloud fire support as far as store using
firebase is defining okay those all look
fine here says coco pods didn't see the
base configuration of your project
because your project already has a
custom config set in order for cocoapods
integration to work at all please either
set the base configuration of the target
runner to target support files blah blah
blah or include the target support files
in your build configuration so this
could actually be very important as we
can see in here so maybe
there was a problem in setting up our
project with flutter create when we said
we created our application to begin with
but let's just keep this in mind and try
to
go in here and open our workspace one
more time and now i can see all the pods
are in here
development pods okay
share plus is right there pod okay
and the pod spec what is the pod spec
says it actually says the platform
should be ios 8 so it supports ios 8 so
that's not a problem so what i'm going
to do now is after doing all these
things i'm going to basically try to
build this project again so i'm going to
do a clean here clean build folder with
command shift k so blink basically clean
your build folder and
all while all of this is going on
editor functionality that's that's fine
so i'm going to basically start doing a
um
product and archive again and then i'll
see you on the other side either this
succeeds or fails and if it fails we're
gonna fix it so let's have a look
okay now i can see
after doing all the gymnastics that i
just had to do
then our application has finally
compiled without a problem and to be
honest with you this is one of the
things that i believe many courses are
missing in that
when you go through distributing your
application you actually go through a
lot it's not just that you press a
button and submit your application and
you're done well usually if everything
is set up correctly then that is the
case however you have to set up
everything correctly
so what happened in here is that we have
to issue a few things what i did
just to name them step by step is that i
first bumped the
deployment target of our application
from 9 to 13. so you can find that by
clicking on your workspace in xcode then
clicking on your runner target general
tab in here and then the deployment
information i bumped it to ios 13 so
that's the first thing that i that i did
however i don't think that that
necessarily had anything to do with
fixing this problem
the other thing that we did from
terminal was to clean
all our pots and i did that by saying
rmrf pods
now we issued that command from the ios
folder if i open this ios folder you'll
see that there is a folder in here
called pods what are pods pods are
basically your applications dependencies
for ios that's how flutter manages your
ios application dependencies so all
these libraries for instance like
firebase and this sharing library that
we just dragged in they're using
basically they are dependencies that
flutter manages using cocoapods which is
a third-party software and you have to
have cocoapods installed on your
computer in order to even be able to
interact with pods so there's lots of
information on the internet on how to
install cocoapods but it's usually
pseudo jam install cocoapods and i think
maybe you can even use homebrew to
install cocoapods but i usually use
sudo jam
or jam in this case but you need sudo
usually to install cocoapods so
so what we did we removed the pots
folder we removed the podfile lock which
for you who are like comfortable with
backing the web development with npm
this is this is like your package lock
file and if you're not comfortable with
back-end development basically a pod
file lock is a file that stores
information about all your dependencies
which are currently installed
whereas the pod file stores information
about which dependencies you need and
pod file log stores information about
the ones that are integrated right now
into your application so we remove that
just to ensure that on the next pod
install
all our dependencies will be freshly
installed and regardless of what is
inside the pod file lock so
there were a few steps that we had to
take but finally we manage oh also we
don't forget flutter clean we also
issued flutter clean so
after all these steps we finally managed
to build our application and as you saw
in this screen we came to this archive
section so
i want to have a look a little bit here
at my notes
to see
um
so yeah we've done the password signing
etc etc and now we basically
um
basically created this
ipa file in here so one you need to do
in here then you press the distribute
app button and say app store connect and
say send send
and this is going to do some analysis on
that binary for you
and it's this is going to connect to app
store connect
and some of you in here may immediately
get an error saying that well i don't
know how to connect and that's because
you haven't entered your
um
profile information in xcode if you go
to xcode preferences there is a section
called accounts and you need to ensure
that you basically add your app apple id
with your account in xcode for any of
that
for the distribution to actually work at
all so i'm going to say app store
connect here and next upload to app
store connect next
so let's go in there
okay
and it says okay upload your app symbols
manage version and build number i don't
really like that so we're gonna take
that off so we're not gonna use that
okay
and let me just make the screen a little
bit bigger and press next in here and
here you have to select your uh profile
and seems fine
press the next button in there and this
is going to contact app store connect
and depending on your application size
this could actually take quite a long
time for some of the applications that
i'm working on
not personally but for various companies
even with my thousand thousand download
upload um
[Music]
internet connection this process could
take a long time so let's see how long
it takes because you see during the
upload process it's not just uploading
your binary it's actually contacting
apple and
even validating a lot of your assets
like your images it's valuing your icons
it's valid validating even if you have
other resources in your application and
i believe it even checks like if you're
making any
api calls which you shouldn't be making
and i'm not talking about network api
calls but i'm actually talking about ios
sdk api calls for instance if you've
hidden some work in your application
which is making uh calls to some um
private apis at the ios sdk level so
now we're just gonna let it do its thing
and upload
and um we'll just wait until it's done
okay well the upload process seems to
have gone
actually a lot better this time and um
and i actually have to really confess to
something in here in that
the upload process for me took a very
very very long time i'm talking about
upwards of 30 minutes even though i'm on
a thousand thousand
um fiber optic
download the upload speed um for my
internet connection this still took a
long time and this could either be a
temporary bug a glitch on apple on
apple's app store connect website or it
could just be something that well from
now on things are gonna take a long time
you never know what apple so
that's unfortunate but at the moment
it's gone through and i can see that um
you will get this message telling you
that your app was uploaded successfully
okay
now let's talk about a um
a push notification email that you'll
receive from apple that will look like
this after submitting your application
you will probably receive an email from
apple that looks kind of like this
and in here as you'll see it says we i i
want more issues with recent delivery of
your application my awesome notes your
delivery was successful but you
mentioned you may wish to correct the
following issues in your next lorry
missing push notification entitlements
and
this may be a bit
troubling for some developers but this
is simply because we're at the moment
using firebase in our application on
firebase is
able to handle push notifications so
that you can send a push notification
from firebase console to your
users however our application isn't
taking advantage of push notifications
at the moment so
you can just disregard this email and
just
don't try to even fix anything because
all this email is saying is that we've
analyzed your binary it looks like you
are accessing some push notification
apis however you forgot to enable push
notifications for applications so and
this is simply because when you bundle
your application and send it to apple as
an ipa
which is something you probably didn't
actually look at but if you go to visual
studio code sorry if you go to xcode in
this archive browser right click on your
runner
and here and say show in finder you'll
see this xcode archive file and say show
package contents and in here you'll
probably see some products and
applications run our app so this whole
thing is like your ipa file that apple
has received now in this runner
application there is information about
what kind of like libraries it has
included in itself and you can actually
right click on run or app and say show
package contents and in here you'll see
all the frameworks that your application
ships with and you can see
firebase etc etc so
one of these frameworks
most probably one of the firebase
frameworks is internally using it has it
is using some apis related to push
notifications but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it is active and
it's actively being used
so that's just an email that apple tells
you that hey you may have forgotten to
do something but you can just disregard
from this email and say no i didn't
forget anything because we don't have
push notifications in our application
okay
so that's that email and
um
so that seems to be fine and after that
email you'll probably also receive an
email that looks like this telling you
that hey your application with this sku
has now been submitted and has completed
processing and this this email literally
means that after
this application's finished processing
you're able to install it on your ios or
mac device and you can test it as you'll
see in the next chapter but
as
we usually do in every chapter at the
end of every chapter we commit to what
we've done and we make sure that we
commit and tag those changes so
let me do some reshuffling on the screen
here
and let's go to and i'm going to close
xcode here like that go to our
application my notes to terminal and
let's just see git status
a few things change so i'm going to go
cd
get status in the main folder of our
application my notes because i was in
the ios folder so i just did cd dot dot
like this so now i'm in the main folder
grid status shows this and i'm just
going to say git add all right and let's
just have a look at our logs the last
commit was step 28 so let's just think
it's commit
step 29 as a caption at the bottom
screen indicates and we just push our
changes
after that is now let's just tag our
changes as well and say step 29
and hit push
tags just like that
all right so that is now working as
expected so
what uh we usually at the end of it at
the end of every chapter is that we talk
about what we when we are going to
discuss in the following chapter and
what we need to do in the next chapter
is actually release our ios application
we've sent it now to apple and apple has
finally finished processing that and
build meaning that it's ready now to be
actually submitted to apple and that's
what we're going to do in the next
chapter to submit the app
for release to the app store so i'll see
you there hello everyone and welcome to
chapter 48 of this flutter course in
previous chapters we've been working
with
creating an ipa file and sending it to
apple and in this chapter we're going to
make sure that we're releasing that ipa
file meaning that we're going to tell
apple that hey we're ready with this ipa
file and we want you to
um review
this file for us and the review process
for apple and and google are a little
bit different in that for instance with
apple sometimes uh there's an actual
user looking at your application and
sometimes if you for instance request a
um a fast review from apple they may not
even look at it and they may just say
okay it just works it's it doesn't crash
and then they it just goes through
um and for google it could also be a
completely different process but
we're right now in this chapter we're
going to focus on how ios app app
submission basically works okay
so
when you send an ipa file like we've
done to apple it will be available in a
place called test flight so let me bring
our web browser to the screen and let's
go and see if we can if you can actually
bring the
views as we had before so let's see app
store connect and i've restarted my
computer since last time so i may have
to basically
log in again and thank god i didn't
actually have to restart the whole
process and actually grab my security
key in here so
it just allowed me to log in so let's go
to my awesome apps in app store connect
and then you'll see a tab up here called
test flight
and test flight as you'll see now our
build then is available in here
and it's ready to be tested basically
so
what we need to also do is to go in here
in the missing compliance and then tap
on this manage and it says does your app
use encryption select yes
and and it says export logs require that
products containing encryption must be
uh properly authorized so in here we
could just say yes
and it says export compliance does your
app
qualify for any of the exams provided in
the category make sure that your app
meets the criteria actually we could go
previous and just say no in here because
we're not directly using um
if you it is your responsibility to
comply with export regulation and you
should revisit this question if your
encryption exists i'll just say blah
blah blah okay
now okay and then we say start internal
testing okay so now that compliance
error is going to go away
so now that we've done that you'll see
that here in app store connect there is
a section called test flight and in here
you have the ability to
for instance invite third-party testers
to your um
to test your application and you are
also allowed to
give access to your application to users
who you've invited to app store connect
so it is very very important to
understand the difference one is
internal testing and the other one is
like if you want to submit your
application to be tested by third
parties like someone who doesn't work
for your company for instance so in this
case we're just going to use internal
testing in this chapter but just know
that test flight
is on ios and mac os an application that
you can actually download on those
operating systems
and you can use test flight in order to
test your own ios applications or mac
applications before
you submit them to app store okay
so that's where test flight
now that we're talking all about all
these let's just also make sure that we
know we have a little bit of a security
problem
um we haven't really talked about it so
much yet but i i built this um with uh
uh in swedish you say midfield and that
is like intentionally intentionally i
built this into this course so you'll
see how the resubmission process also
works so
if if we bring our code let's let's
bring our mynotes code in here
and have a look at our
um i believe was one of our services
notes service
oops
no service is completely oh because that
was the crowd service so
let's have a look at the service and
cloud note and we have
crowd cloud storage cloud firebase cloud
storage it's called okay i'd forgotten
the name and we had this little all
field in here you see
so what this all field at the moment is
doing is saying that go get all the
notes in
all the notes in the notes collection
so that's doing that and then from all
the notes remember all the notes not
only your notes
it's taking and creating a cloud note
and then it's filtering them out by who
you are that is a huge security problem
because
by doing this subscription and getting
this stream you're pretty much reading
everyone else's notes as well what we
want soon we're gonna fix that don't
worry about it what we want is to not
even allow any user to read someone
else's notes okay and then we're going
to change this
implementation of all notes and resubmit
our application to apple
so
i didn't want us to submit an app to
apple and then to google and then have
to resubmit it in both platforms because
as i said planned this so i just wanted
us to submit something only to one
platform and then draw it back and then
send it again but don't worry about this
yet i'm just giving you some preparation
of what's to come
so
what we need to do now first is to as
the caption at the bottom of the screen
in the case we need to install test
flight for both ios and you also have to
install it for um
your mac on on the mac you can just go
to app store on your macintosh so app
store app and then search for test
flight okay
after
search for test flight you can install
it with this install button i have it
installed already on my computer so i
don't see a install button in here i can
just open it
and after you've done that um for your
macintosh you'll also need to install it
for your um
ios device and here
i actually have my iphone my little
iphone 13 pro max here
and i have i'm
mirroring that iphone here on the screen
as you can see so what you can see on
the screen is actually my iphone right
here okay
and test flight is an application which
is available right here so this is the
test flight application on ios so at the
moment you can see that i don't have
access to my nodes application but we're
going to fix that soon or my awesome
notes as we call it okay
so let's go ahead in here and have a
look at the next thing we need to talk
about and that's adding a user to to
test light so how do i get access to um
to
this build that we've submitted so that
i can test it with test flight well the
user that i've used for testing in here
and i know that user it's
pixelity.sweden
gmail.com so what i'm going to do now is
to invite that user to test this build
so let's go to internal testing and
press the plus button and in here i'm
just going to say my users okay
and then press the create button
and in here you'll see a plus button
tester 0 and i'm just going to say plus
and in here i'm just going to use a
pixel to switch so i'm just going to say
add in here
okay and it says one tester has been
added to this group and that's pretty
much it so i don't have to do anything
extra there
so what i'm gonna do then is going to
wait for um an email to be sent by app
store connect to my user and it's just
been sent i'm gonna open it so you can
also see it how it looks like here's the
email that i just received so app store
connect is telling me that hey you've
now been invited to and test this
application and you can just go ahead
and do it so i'm just gonna tap on view
in test flight and this is just gonna
work because i already have um
basically a test light installed on my
macintosh so let me just tap on that and
i can see test flight open on a separate
screen i'll bring it to the screen here
and i can accept in basically installing
this application so as the bottom
as the bottom captioning indicates we've
already looked at the email
it looked like this and now we're going
to install this application which is a
flutter application
but we're installing it on a macintosh
and that's just great so let's just
accept this and you can see now i can
either say install or done so i'm just
gonna say done so you see it so this is
our application here and i'm just gonna
press the install button and this is
just gonna go to app store connect and
grab that binary and bring it down
so and i can just press the open button
and if everything goes well this is our
flutter application running on this
macintosh
but it is an ios app we didn't actually
compile this to be running on a
macintosh so everything is just working
as it should i can even log in here
right like that
and then in here it's a foo bar bass
log in
and i can see my note so it's working as
expected so i'm just going to close the
app now all right
so
what we need to do now is to submit this
build we've looked at it it seems to be
working fine so i'm just going to close
test flight here and close this email
let's then go to app store connect and
let's go to this app store section in
here and in this ios app section here
1.0 prepare for submission let's scroll
down to the place that says build and we
need to then say select a build before
you submit your app okay now
remember uh
if you don't see this blue button in
here that's because you've probably just
submitted your bill to apple
apple usually takes up to 30 minutes or
sometimes even more to validate your
build so they may not have even appeared
in here especially if it's the first
build that you're
sending to apple it may take a while for
them to process it so you may not see
this button simply because there is no
valid build yet but you can test you can
check the status of your builds by just
going to this test flight section and
just having a look at the version that
you've submitted and if there is if that
build is still processing it will just
say uh paranthesis processing and the
icon will just be a little bit grayed
out okay so don't worry it's not there's
nothing wrong you just have to wait a
little bit
so in here i'm just going to say select
a bill before you submit your app and
then say one that build that i'd
submitted all right so and then i'm just
gonna press the save button
so that's for the
build so age rating in app store connect
go to app information and fill in age
rating and i believe we've already done
this so if if you've not done that
before please go ahead and take care of
that but i explained this in one of the
previous chapters so you may have to go
and edit your age rating if you want to
but if you have followed the chapters
chronologically you should have done
this
by this point
okay
we also need to take care of our app
privacy so we need to go to app privacy
as the caption at the bottom of the
screen indicates and here we have to get
started by
filling out
our app privacy and
as you can see in here if you have an
application that collects a lot of data
you i don't want to scare you but you
may kind of be in trouble because you
will have to inform apple about all
those things what you're collecting from
the user okay
so let's let's in here let's say do you
or third party partners collect data
from this app then we should say yes in
here right because we are collecting
data and that is
the user's for instance email address
password and notes so let's just say yes
in here's a data types that meet all of
the following criteria are optional to
disclosure the data is not used for
tracking
we're not using it for tracking the data
is not used for third party we're not
doing that collection of data occurs
only in infrequent cases okay so we
pretty much are not
doing any of those tracking stuff that
they're saying here so
let's go in here and say data collection
yeah we're collecting your email address
and
that's it
we're not collecting any financial
information location
contacts user content
photos audio gameplay none of that
any other user generated contents yes
browsing history no search history no
user ids
screen name handle account id
yes we are
device id we're not
um
diagnosis crash data we're not doing
that at the moment
and other data so yeah this seems fine
so for now we can just say identifier to
user id we also said other user content
because we're collecting the users
generated notes and we're also
collecting their email address so let's
just say saving here
okay and it says additional setup
required so let's go ahead and fix those
now in email address let's go set up
email address so i'm going to click
there and are we using it for third
party no
developer advertising no analytics no
product personalization
customizing what the user sees such as a
list of recommended products for no
app functionality yes that's what we're
doing so press next
and are the email addresses collected
from this app linked to the user's
identity
link to the yes email address collector
link to the user's identity
are there i mean this is this is a
little bit of a legal question so i'm
not best
um
placed here to
answer this but i mean an email isn't
necessarily connected to someone's
identity as a person because i can just
go create like a private email and no
one knows about so i'm just gonna answer
no
tracking email address
okay next
um
okay
doesn't seem like okay do you or
third-party partners use email addresses
for tracking purposes nope okay
and saved okay so
the email address stuff is saved now
let's go to other user content which is
the user generated notes okay so
indicate how other user content
collected from this app is being used
um advertising no analytics no
customization no and app functionality
of course
so let's then go and say is user content
collected from the sub link to the
user's identity
they're used they're linked to the
user's email and since we said email is
not linked to the user's identity i'm
just gonna reason to say no in here
do you or third-party partners use other
user content for tracking purposes nope
okay so that part is done as well then
let's go to identifiers for user id so
i'm just going to click there
and remember user id in here is that uid
that firebase creates okay remember that
so we're using that for app
functionality okay
are the user ids collected from this app
linked to the user's identity
user id
user identity
i would say yes it is quite obvious so
let's just say yes
do you or third party partners use user
ids for tracking purposes nope
nope
all right so saved and that's that now
you've gone through the privacy policy
and this is like that
basically what happens is
apple will
display this to users when they try to
download your application this is very
important that you fill in to the best
of your knowledge and ability this is
not the place that you go and fake
anything and say try to hide the
information that you're collecting from
the users it is in the in your best
interest in your product's best interest
and in your company's best interest to
make sure that you fill these in as best
as you can okay usually in bigger
companies you'd want to probably um
consult with a lawyer or somebody who's
um good at making sure you're not
missing anything so in a big company you
usually don't do this on your own but
since we're now assuming that you're a
simple like a single entity even if
you're behind an organization like me
but you're a single entity and trying to
do this to the best of your ability okay
so now what we need to do is also fill
in this um
let's see here privacy policy so
what this is as you can see in here a
url that links to the privacy policy
privacy policy is required for all apps
and as you can see at the bottom of the
screen i've actually included a little
privacy policy for my own website and
i've included that let's see
if i can log in in here
let's see if i can do it on a separate
window so you don't have to be bothered
by that
because i've actually included that um
you know what i will actually do it on a
separate screen so you don't have to be
bothered by that and um
so
i will go to
i'll go to my hosting website and i'll
take care of that and then i'll bring it
to the screen so you can actually see it
so
let's see if i can go to my hosting in
here and then go to my
hosting
basically
well all my file files are residing
excuse me
and i'll bring it in here so let's have
a look at this url that i provided at
the bottom of the screen you can see
pixel dsc privacy policy so i'm going to
go to
dub dub up there and i have a look at
this text file which is right there
privacy policy so if i type pixelity
excuse me privacy policy you see that
there is a generic privacy policy that
i've placed in my website
and you will need to do the same thing
so you'll need to basically grab a
privacy policy from somewhere and look
at that privacy policy and make sure
that it works for you so what i did is i
found a website
and i'm not just going to go advertising
here but you can find free privacy
policy written by a very good and smart
people and you can have a look at those
adjust them to make sure that they make
sense for you and your company and for
instance in here i've just taken a
generic privacy policy
let's see if i can find it here
so i put my company name in there and i
just ensure that it makes sense for my
company and i've just basically put it
inside that url that you can see at the
bottom of the screen so i'm going to go
in here at privacy and app store connect
and say privacy policy edit and in the
privacy policy url i'm just going to say
https pixelity
dot se and then i'm just going to say
privacy
policy.txt but for you this should be
something else okay and i'm just going
to copy that open it and make sure that
it exists and then i'm going to press
the save button okay
so after we've done that we also need to
make sure that we've taken care of our
categories the categories to which our
application belongs so let's go to app
information at the bottom of the screen
indicates i'm going here in the category
and the primary category we're going to
say our app belongs to productivity and
then it belongs to utilities okay
here utilities all right then i'm gonna
save this information
okay then what we need to also do before
we submit our app for review is that
just remember this application is going
to be reviewed by an actual human so
this person is literally going to get
this information in the queue of their
work they're going to say oh an
application called my awesome notes
needs to be reviewed
and then they're going to say okay
they're going to have some control panel
on their screen i don't know really how
it's formed on apple's site but they're
going to then download this application
on various devices automatically perhaps
and then they're gonna open the app and
then like how am i supposed to use this
app so
it is in your best interest to ensure
that you provide all information
possible to that person so that they can
review your application so what you need
to do then is to go inside app
here prepare for submission in here app
review information and then under notes
just tell that person
what your how your application works and
how they need to register so in here
what we're going to say is um
you you will need
a valid email address
in order
to register
please follow these
steps to register now i'm gonna say um
open the register view and register
with the email
and password of your choosing
you're choosing
wait for a confirmation email
wait for a confirmation email from
to be to be sent to your email address
and in the confirmation
click
on the link to confirm your email
address
okay and then step three is go back
to the app and in the login screen
log
in with
your email and password
and that's it so
we've done that now so i'm gonna
actually then provide a valid phone
number in here and since i don't want to
really share my like phone number
everywhere on the internet i'm just
going to
go on to a separate screen here and
write my valid phone number in here
um
but that's my phone number great and
let's then
go here and then i'm going to press save
button as well
and then bring the screen here perfect
so now i've saved that information
including my phone number and everything
should be ready at this point
so what you need to do then is to
go and grab some popcorn while you're
doing this hopefully and then you'll
just need to say submit for review
and
it says the items below need to be okay
we haven't really done the price pricing
and then it saw it says an admin must
provide information about the app's
privacy practices in app privacy section
it seems like we missed some stuff so
let's go to pricing and availability and
fix that this application is going to be
free so i'm just going to say it doesn't
cost anything and save that so that's
for pricing
and let's go to app privacy and see if
we've actually missed anything doesn't
seem like it but what we've forgotten is
to actually press the publish button so
let's just publish that
okay then we go back in here and then we
say submit
that's great so now your application is
submitted to app store and a reviewer
from the app store connecting is going
to have a look at your application so
that they can
confirm that it works according to the
information that you've provided and i
can see that i actually got an email
from apple that looks like this and it
says the status of your application has
changed to waiting for review so it's
not a waiting game so
um but before before we actually do all
of this we
whether apple has had the time to review
our application and
accept it
or they found some bugs in it and
rejected our application
whichever case we need to draw back this
build and i will show you how in the
upcoming chapters because we have the
security bug that i told you about so
for now we can just be happy that we've
gone through this chapter we've done
quite a lot of work
and um
pat yourself on the back just great job
and grab some uh
maybe a tea or coffee
and we can get start to actually get
ready for the next chapter and i'll tell
you actually what we need to talk about
in the next chapter and that is this
little um
problem that we had in the all notes and
we need to fix this before we can go
live with android as well so
now you know what's coming in the
upcoming chapters and um
i'll see you there hello everyone and
welcome to chapter 49 of this flutter
course in previous chapters we've
submitted our application to um
app store connect and
we also briefly talked about the fact
that we have a little bit of a security
problem in our firebase firestore
database
so let's have a look at what the actual
problem is so i explained this briefly
in the previous chapters but i'll do it
again in here so let's have a look
um so if this is our code i'm going to
increase the size so we'll see it better
and you'll see that when we are working
with displaying all the notes on the
screen for a user so for instance user a
has signed into the application
and inside our
notes view
if you go there we'll see that we're
subscribing to all nodes in here in our
stream builder so we're saying we're
basically building our entire list view
which is here now it's list view and
we're building it on top of the data
that comes from this all nodes function
which is at the moment inside our
firebase cloud storage okay
however if you look at this code you'll
see that what it is doing is referring
to this node's private um
or this node's local variable and which
is right here and this notes at the
moment is
pointing to the notes collection
and what it does it literally takes all
the notes from the notes collection so
this look this essentially means any
user logged into our application is
truly retrieving all the nodes in the
entire database
although
at the end of that code what we're doing
is saying we're okay after we retrieve
all the nodes from the database
then we're mapping them here to cloud
nodes so we can consume them locally
and
right at the end we're saying hey but
we're only interested in notes that are
for discard user
but
even though the current login user is
not going to see all the notes in the
database but the current user is reading
all the notes in the database and if you
perform a man in the middle attack for
instance if you're using charles proxy
on a computer and then you're
using your phone and you're using for
instance let's say you have charles
proxy on your computer and then you're
sharing your wi-fi connection from an
ethernet connection through wi-fi with
an iphone that is running your
application if i don't sit in the middle
with charles proxy and look at all the
traffic that's going from your flutter
application to firebase then i can
actually see you requesting information
about all those notes and then those
notes coming back to the application so
a man in the middle attack could
potentially then expose all data in our
database or in the notes collection at
least so we need to
we need to fix this so
what we're going to do is by is to start
by removing our application from app
store connect if you remember in the
previous chapters we sent our
application to apple for review and what
i've done in here i've developer
rejected this application essentially so
let me have a look and see if i can
increase the size of the screen so we
submitted our application to app store
connect for review from the apple um
team review team but right before it
actually went to review i refreshed the
screen in here and you didn't see this
but i said remove this application from
review if you remove your own
application from review basically it
will become this it will go to the state
developer rejected so this is basically
informing you that hey it's not apple
basically rejecting your application it
is you yourself who's done this so
so i can show you an example how
that
confirmation email from apple will look
like so i'll open it in a separate
screen
and it kind of looks like this i'll
bring it to this main screen so you see
it as well okay
all right
so there we go so then i received an
email from apple that said that status
of your app has changed to developer
rejected app name blah blah okay so
this is the email that you'll receive so
i need you to basically reject your
application
the version one zero that you sent to
apple because we have security problems
with that application okay and again
i've mentioned this in the previous
chapters i did this in on purpose so
that we can understand like someone
because this is the kind of stuff that
you're going to go through as a software
developer sometimes you're going to
submit something to apple or google and
then you understand you made a mistake
so how do you how do you fix that and i
really wanted this to be a part of this
um
course so you understand how you reject
your application how you fix the problem
and how you resubmit the application
okay but i didn't want to do it for both
ios and android because it just gets
boring if you have to submit first go
through the entire submission from two
platforms and then to submit again so
that's why we first submitted for ios
and then we're gonna fix it and then
once that's fixed we're also gonna
submit for android okay
so after rejecting your application you
also need to basically remove your build
from this at 1.0 so i i believe i've
already done that oh no i haven't so
it's actually good i haven't done that
so let's go ahead and here in 1.0 and
just remove this build okay so we say we
don't want to submit anything and then
press save okay
all right um and also as you can see at
the bottom of the screen we're going to
update this 1.0 version now to 1.1 so
let's go and see if he can find that
information so right now
i also saw that i got an email from
apple and here says okay now it's
prepared for submission meaning that
it's not developed or rejected anymore
and let's just bump this version in here
to 1.1
0.0 okay and then i'm going to save it
well and here i mean this is kind of
like a it depends on your taste if you
want to resubmit 1.0 you're more than
welcome to do that but it's usually
if you change something in your code
then it is usual for you to go and
update this um
minor version and it's called so because
this first version is the major version
so if there's a huge future in the
application and this is the
minor version and here is a patch i mean
you could argue that we could i
essentially maybe change our application
version to one zero one because this is
a patch but i just choose to do one one
zero okay
so let's go ahead and i'm assuming that
you're doing the same thing because
there's some information i'm gonna
provide to you a little bit later in
this chapter that relies on you having
actually changed your app version to one
one zero okay
so that's that part is done what we need
to do now is to go as a caption in case
we're gonna go clean
all the notes and users in our firestore
database so let's go ahead and see if we
can get that to work so
my notes flutter project so that's in
your
firebase console and i'm going to go
first to authentication to users there's
just one user in here i'm just going to
delete that account okay then i'm going
to go to firestore database and there's
probably two notes in the notes
collection and i'm going to delete them
as well so delete documents there and
then delete this document as well okay
so we have a clean slate no users and no
notes in the database
so you may be wondering well if we have
security problems with our database
shouldn't firebase be intelligent enough
to know that and firebase is actually
intelligent enough to know that and
sometimes you will receive emails from i
mean depending on the security holes in
your database you will receive emails
from at firebase telling you that hey
there is something wrong with your
security rules and i've prepared some
email that that kind of indicates that i
just wanted to show you how that kind of
email looks like
so you can see if you have security
issues with your fire firebase and
firestore database you may receive
something like this you see it says
we've detected the following issues with
your security rules any user can read
your entire database so
it kind of looks like this okay so just
know that if you receive an email like
that then you know at least the reason
for it okay
and if you're wondering more about like
security rules and
how you have to configure them although
i'm going to tell you how we're going to
configure our security rules in this
chapter but if you're wondering how to
do that on your own and you're curious
about reading more about it i've
prepared a little link here so let me
see if i can actually bring it
to the screen
by opening
a link and it kind of looks like this so
you see firebase google.com docs first
our security rules
and conditions so
and so you can read about this and i did
that and i got a lot of inspiration from
how to
fix our security uh problem in our
firestore database so i strongly suggest
that you actually read this
documentation you don't have to do it
right now but please just at least um
bookmark this page so you can come back
to it later
okay so now to the point let's go and
fix our security issue in our firestore
database okay so i've also prepared here
how we have to actually do it and you
can see the let me actually bring up our
security rules so go to firestore
database tab in your firebase console
and then go to rules okay let's have a
look at all roles at the moment and how
they're set up so the way it's set up at
the moment you can see it says match any
database and any documents okay and
that's what we're doing here as well and
it says match any document in there so
at the moment we're allowing read and
write access only if you're
authenticated so okay so let's just for
now say we are allowing create
if you're authenticated so we say you
should be able to create a node as long
as you're authenticated so let's say
create and you can see we get some help
from firebase as well in here okay
so that's that so creation and then we
say allow
read write and update
okay and this is the rules that we're
going to write in here you can see read
update actually read update and delete
so
so read updates and delete and the way
we have to set it up is of course as you
can see in here what i preferred is we
first need to make sure anyone tries to
read from our database or update the
database or delete the document should
be authenticated so
let's go in here and say okay if
authenticated
we'll bring that code up here okay
but we're also going to add some more
information to it and the information
should like look like this you can see
in this document in here
you may be like okay but how do i know
because okay before i actually say that
what we want is for the currently
authenticated user id
to only be able to access his or her
documents that have the same user id
remember in our code we have this user
id field let me bring it up here
so if you go to our storage here we have
these constants and we have this user id
field so every node that we store in our
firestore database has a user id field
so what we want in here is to basically
grab the user id from the request so if
you say in here request you'll see we
have off path resource so let's go off
and then you'll see there's something
called a uid and that is the user id
okay so if we have a look how we have to
actually do that so we're saying user
request rtu id should be equal to
resource data user id and this resource
is the current resource that the user is
trying to access okay and if you read
the documentation that i provided to you
earlier you'll you would know this so
let's go in here and say okay the
request auth uid should be equal to
resource
beta dot user id because that's the
field that we provided um as you saw in
the code here so let's then um
yeah i think this is good to go so we
could then publish these changes and it
says publish changes can take up to a
minute to propagate and that's
completely fine because we're actually
going to take some time in order to
update
our code as well okay so that's our
security rule so let's just make sure
that they look like this and i'm gonna
actually bring it to two lines so you
can see it in its entirety
um if you need to get some um
inspiration from this you can also build
on top of this tomorrow so you can add
more security to this so you're more
welcome to
um
then what we need to do is
start cleaning up our code on the dart
site so on the dart side so
let's have a look at this code that
we've written in here i'm going to
change the screen layout a little bit so
you see it better
so let's go to this function gets notes
and you may have noticed it but gets
notes at the moment we're not using this
function at the moment so we're only
using all nodes so let's go ahead and
just remove this gets notes from
firebase cloud storage okay
just like that
i'm running the application at the
moment so let's just command s and i can
see there's no problems because no one
is actually using get notes and there's
no
errors in our code you can see there's
no files or folders that are marked as
red so
um so that's that one that was one of
the things that we have to do just to
remove the get nodes
and then what we need to do in here is
to ensure that our when we're actually
saying all notes that we are filtering
the snapshots before we actually read
them so let's just go in here and say
notes and before snapshots f like this
i'm gonna say where
and you can see it says okay which field
are you looking for then we say owner
user id
field name
and that should actually be is equal to
and we have the owner
it's ready right
so that's that one and then after that
we say snapshot and snapshots map
and
that's also fine actually so
in to be honest with you we could clean
this code up as well so let's just say
in here
and we take this and we say this is our
notes
excuse me
the final notes is equal to that
for all notes
and we could just return it
all right so now we have this and you
could basically argue saying that okay
we have a where clause in here so we
don't have to have this word clause in
here and i would actually say yeah that
does make sense because yeah why would
we have two word clauses so let's just
remove that word clause and put the
semicolon in here
okay so we filter before we read all the
snapshots all right we're getting an
error in here let me see what the
problem could be because there's a map
all right
so your code basically should look like
this right now
and what we can do now is to actually
put this to test to make sure
everything's working as expected so i'm
gonna bring our ios simulator in here
which the application is running on
already gonna do a hot restart and let's
just register a user so i'm just gonna
say
van.np
gmail.com foo barbeaus and please don't
use this uh password say register and
then it says verify email okay
and let me go ahead and bring up my
mails
and have a look at my email and see if a
verification email has been sent to me
and we've sent an email verification
please open it to verify your account
and i hope i actually entered my email
correctly because i haven't yet received
a verification email
so perhaps i could open up gmail in a
separate tab because i'm using gmail at
the moment for that particular user
and see if that email has appeared in my
gmail inbox
okay
i'm gonna switch users
all right let's see
and this is i'm doing this on a separate
screen so that's why you're not seeing
any of this happening
um i can't see really any email at the
moment so um let me go ahead in our
firebase console in here so
um let's go here
and let's go then to authentication and
i can see that there is a user here and
that is actually correct but i don't see
any verification email being sent to me
so let's go ahead and have a look at our
register view
and let's have a look at the button
implementation if we actually forgot to
do something so when we pass this
register event you can see auth event
register then we have to go to our off
block
and have a look at how we've implemented
implemented that i can see that we say
create user and then we're awaiting on
the provider send email verification so
it seems to be working fine however i
still haven't received any verification
email and that's why i'm just going to
say send email verification here on this
screen
and by pressing that i'm just going to
refresh my emails and now i can see i
received a verification email i'm going
to bring it here tap on the link and i
can see that i saw this um i can see
that
your email has been verified was
displayed to me so
that's great let's go ahead now and um
go to the application and i'm going to
restart here go to the login page and
i'm going to log in with that user
fu
barbaz
log in with the user and no problems i
can log into the application press the
plus button and i'm going to say my
first note
okay
that's saved and then i'm going to save
my second note
all right and that is also saved then
i'm going to log out
and try to log back in with another user
so let's register a new user because
remember we deleted all our users from
firestore database so who are about
again please don't use this password
and i'm going to have a look at my
emails then
and i can actually see a new
verification email was sent to me so
that's perfect i'm going to bring it
here
if i can open that email it looks like
this i'm going to verify my user great
then i'm going to restart the process
and try to log in with that user
okay
through barbaz
log in with the user and i can't see van
dot's
notes so i'm going to say another first
note
another first note
and
create a new note say another second
note all right so after these two users
have created their own two individual
notes let's go ahead in our database
refresh the users we can see there are
two users in here one starting with pg
which is this pixelity and then there's
a 9v which is the other user okay
let's go to our database and see how
many nodes we have and we can see we
have four nodes
9v
9v which is for default.user and then we
have two
um documents created by
the pixelity email which start with the
user id of pg as you can see in here and
they they have full access to their own
documents so now this user you can
actually go and delete this document for
instance another first note so he can go
and say okay i want to delete this note
so boom
and you can see it just immediately got
deleted from firebase as well so
they have full access to their own notes
but they have absolutely no access to
anybody else's notes alright so that's
working fantastically
if that's even a word fantastically
so the next thing we need to do now that
we fix this is to go ahead and update
the build number in our pop spec yaml
file so now i'll show you this let's go
to visual studio code to our code right
here and then say pop spec
um
camel and you'll see on top of this file
somewhere around here we have this
version at the moment is one zero zero
plus one but what we want to do in here
is just is to say it's one one zero plus
one so we're updating our build number
in here as well okay
so after doing that since it's such a
big change you could perhaps look at
your terminal and see and do a git
status and you can see by updating that
build number in here um
it didn't immediately update the build
number for our application because had
it done that it should have also been
updated for our ios application in the
info plist file so that unfortunately
wasn't updated and because of this it's
probably a good idea to issue flutter
clean so i'm going to bring the
code like that let's just say flutter
clean
okay
that's gonna do its work
and let's say flutter
pop get
that
and
all right that's doing is we're going to
say git status let's have a look at our
status and there's still nothing changed
so let's just say flutter run ios
and see if that's gonna listen okay
flutter run because that's our default
target at the moment is an ios simulator
so maybe flutter rom will just accept
multiple devices found
all right
show us the list of devices please
perhaps
it's having oh now it found it please
choose one okay i want to choose the
iphone 13 pro so i'm gonna choose um
iphone 13 pro number two in here okay
so now it's gonna build the project with
xcode build and in my experience these
days
xcode build has been
it's just horribly slow so
i'm basically gonna stay quiet now let
it do its work and when it's done we
will continue with the video
all right as i suspected this process
actually took a very long time and i
think we could actually see in here that
the xcode build took 164
seconds
it is well i'm not going to go into that
it's a long time um so let's have a look
now if the version was actually updated
correctly so i'm going to go another
into another shell in here and let's say
git status and i still don't see any
info plist files have been getting
changed on the ios side so i'm just
gonna be curious here and then go to the
ios file in here and have a look at the
xcode workspace
and let's have a look at the version in
here well the version does seem to have
been updated so it's 1 1 0 that's
exactly what we specified in our pop
spec yaml so that's you making sure that
this file is updated and if you don't
have xcode so if you're for instance
running on
linux
ubuntu or something and you want to
still check whether the version number
was updated for the ios application you
can always do that by opening up this
file info plist inside ios runner
and then you can have i believe you
could have a look at
your flutter build number in here and
let's see if flutter build number is set
somewhere
that one that one
i don't actually see the flutter build
number being set anywhere
so if we search for one one zero
actually let's search for one one zero
in the entire application and the only
thing i can see in here are like some of
our pop specs
and
one one zero in here so
unfortunately that's not gonna work so
i don't really know the magic behind how
the flutter team has actually injected
that 110 into
it's probably some sort of a build
variable so if you want to get into
details about that perhaps we could just
open xcode
and have a look at that application
let's go in here into build settings and
have a look at the version
um and see if there's any one one zero
in here flutter build name exactly so
that's that's how they're injecting it
they have a user defined variable called
slots are built and flutter build the
name is then being injected for our info
p list so
if you go here you can see oh this is
flutter build number so yeah but anyway
it's this this must be a variable that
the flutter team has injected into the
xcode build somehow all right
but bringing up xcode could confirm that
the version number is set to 110
correctly so that's all we needed to do
then the next step for this chapter for
us is to
make a build and send it to apple this
time so
not this time we did it the previous
time as well we sent it to apple so what
i'm going to do is i need to bring up
xcode again i shouldn't have closed it
maybe let's go in here and while we're
in there we could just go and say we're
building for any ios device and then i'm
just going to say product archive as
we've done in the previous chapters as
well
so let it do its work
okay now our build has been um created
by xcode and in here it's very important
that you actually check that the version
number in here
corresponds to the version number that
you've created in app store connect and
just a reminder in app store connect if
you go back there you can see that the
version that we prepared is 110 and
that's why i said in the beginning of
this chapter it's actually important for
you to follow the same versioning that
i'm doing in in the current chapter so
let's say 110 and i'm going to say
distribute to apple or distribute app
upload
and let's go in here
analyzing app version fetching app store
configuration
and i'm going to uncheck manage version
and build number because i want flutter
to be able to do that and then i'm going
to choose the production profile that
we've created for application press the
next button in here as well
and then depending on your network
connection and your and different
configurations that you have for your
network this process could actually take
a very very long time
previously when i tried this even even
though i'm on a fiber optic net network
connection
with a thousand upload a thousand
download it still took about 30 minutes
for a simple application to be sent to
apple and it was literally stuck in this
requesting app information for more than
20 minutes so
that's an unfortunate fact that we just
have to accept and let it do its work
and
i will see you then once it's
finally sent the application to apple
all right so now i can see that our
application has been submitted to apple
and i have to confess that this time it
took only about a minute for this
process to go through so that was very
fast much much faster than the previous
chapters we'd have to submit our
application which took upwards of 30
minutes for me
so now that it's done after you've done
this you will receive an email from
apple that kind of looks like this if i
can bring it to the screen
it will look like this and it will tell
you that
the following build has completed
processing only after this email has
been sent you can go to app store
connect and
go and we also have to fix our missing
compliance so let's just say manage and
say
use encryption no
start internal testing after you've done
that you need to go to the app store
how do you say tab
and in that tab let's just select a new
bill and it's our 110 build and i'm
going to say done in there okay after
you've done that you can press the save
button and then you can submit your
application
fresh to apple so that
then in turn concludes the submission of
our app to app store and um if there's
any complications with this application
like if apple for some reason can't
register a user or something they're
going to send you an email telling you
about that so
then you need to go through that process
and help the app store
review team in order to get started with
your application but if you remember
from the previous chapters we've
actually left some information in there
like review information
and told the review team how to register
for a
user in our application so that
information should be sufficient for
them to understand how to use the app
fantastic we're done with the origin
with the submission of our ios app to
app store so as usual since we've now
changed our code let's go into
visual studio code and
i'm going to close all these tabs
because it's just extremely populated on
my screen
get rid of the explorer and go to
my terminal in here and have a look at
art status and i can see there's only
two files changed so i'm going to add
them and let's commit as step 30 as you
can see at the bottom of the screen okay
so if you look at our logs we have step
29 and then we have step 30 so i'm going
to say git push
that's going to push our commit
and less than a tag v so step 30 and
let's just say get push tags so
that is done now and our tag of 30 is
also sent to a github
what we need to do now as usual is
tradition where we talk about what we
need to discuss in the upcoming chapters
and in the next chapter we're going to
talk about sending our app also to
google play store we've done it for ios
we have to do the same process for
google play store so get some
refreshments if you want to and i'll see
you in the next chapter hello everyone
and welcome to chapter 50 of the slotted
course in previous chapters we've been
working quite a lot with submitting our
application for the ios app store using
app store connect and in this chapter
we're going to focus on doing the same
thing but for
google and play store so whereas you
have app store and at the back of app
store you have the
um app store connect which allows you as
a developer to go and interact with the
your product that's going to be
submitted to the app store google has
something similar for your product for
your android app in this case our
flutter application to be available in
the google play store
which is where users download your
applications you you as a developer will
have to go to the google play console so
we're going to take care of that and for
that we're going to create something
called an app bundle where whereas if
you remember when we created our ios
application we went to xcode and archive
our application and that created
something called an xc archive file and
that was kind of like a zip file
and all your files were all your
binaries at least all your like linked
libraries all your pods the application
itself binary was signed with your
production certificate and profile an
app bundle for
your um android devices as well is a
signed bundle so it is the equivalent of
your um xc archive kind of and we're
going to take care of that as well soon
in this chapter
and we have a um
i mean there's something that i i
actually prefer this but i didn't want
to mention it before because we were so
close to actually raising our ios
application we have to make just some
small adjustments to our code as well as
you'll soon see when we
start for instance working with
taking screenshots of our android of our
flutter app running on various android
devices and that's um a scrolling issue
that we have generally on our
screens where we display the keyboard
those screens are
um
login view and i believe there's
register view
and where else do we display a keyword i
believe we also
log in register for a got password view
because we asked the user for
her email address there as well and also
one year for instance um
actually we don't have the problem on
the edit notes view so that's not a
problem so
we have this problem in verify email
view login view register view and forgot
password view
so um
actually verify email view you could
argue that yeah it's it's not a problem
but
so the issue that we have at the moment
is that imagine that your application
application is being run on a very small
screen
and um
and then the user for instance has a
very very small screen and then they're
on the login view and then we displayed
the keyboard where at where for instance
they tap on the email field and they try
to write their email and then the
keyboard pops up blocking like half the
screen and depending on the size of the
screen the rest of the half that is
remaining might not actually be able to
display the entire contents of your
view
so
this is a little problem and we have to
fix it but it is so simple to fix and
you may then decide to say well the ios
application we've done already is sent
to apple it's um it's already accepted
and i'm going to release it and you
could definitely do that so it's
actually good practice if you want to
release your is application as is just
go ahead and do that and then you can do
a patch later and release another
application to fix that issue
and i think the more you release
applications the better because then you
learn the process of updating things and
sending release notes etc it's just good
practice to do that quite
often so let's go ahead now and talk a
little bit about the documentation for
creating an app bundle so i'll bring it
up
here
and it's as you can see at the bottom of
the screen it's in distribute console
and um
there's a lot of documentation here that
you can go and read more about it so i
thought just to um explain like the
google play console in here a little bit
to you so that you can sign in here
and then you can read more about all
these topics so i think it's just a good
url for you to um
bookmark if you want to be able to
release your application in the future
as well with google and play store
otherwise if you're like me and you
sometimes just want to jump into things
you could start by
um logging into google play console so
let me bring you to the next url as you
can see the url is played at google.com
console about so i'm just gonna say um
play.google.com slash console slash
out
if i can spell
and that's our google play console okay
and i'm just going to log in here with
my
a user account and i have this user
account here which i can log in with
let's see if i can log in successfully
with that
all right and then it says choose
developer again and if you haven't done
this before you may have to go and
create a developer account first but i
but
in the beginning of this chapter we
talked quite a lot about creating a
developer account both for ios and
android so i'm assuming you've already
done that but if you haven't you can go
and create a developer account it is
free you don't have to pay for anything
so just go ahead and create your
developer account
so now here i'm going to choose my
developer account and just go in here
okay so here's my google
play console as you can see in here this
is the console url for me at least and
what we need to do in here is to go
ahead and create an app so
let's go ahead as you can see at the
bottom of the screen let's go ahead and
tap on create app in here and now in
here it's asking us for some information
um and also i just saw that i have a
little um
ipo in my
action so i'll bring the right caption
up in here and you'll see that we have
to go through these steps in order to
create our application all right so i'm
gonna go in here and let's just say my
awesome
notes
the default language let's just leave it
as english us and and it asks you is it
an app or a game then we're gonna say
it's an application and it's a free
application
and and and we're going to say it it
meets the developer policies and accept
us export laws okay and then we create
the application this may take some
time okay so
what we need to do now is to go through
um
app access in here so i'm going to bring
up the caption
so we need to go through let's see if
you can actually find the provided
information about your app and as you
can see it's right here provide
information about your app and set up
your store listening okay so i'm gonna
have a look at that and these are the
things you have to go through and we're
actually gonna go through this together
to in order to be able to create a
listing for your application so it's a
good check checklist basically um and
i have to say i mean i'm more used to
the app store connect interface it's a
little bit like less cluttered i find
google play console a little bit more
cluttered to be honest with you and
things are just
there are so much in your face but once
you get used to it i think you'll
understand the purpose and
and then you'll just as as long as you
know where to find things so in the
dashboard and for your application just
scroll down to set up your app provide
information here about your app instead
of your store listing and let's go to
app access and set that up okay
and then here is asking us okay is there
any restricted content that we're going
to say
all functionalities available without
special access press the save button
and you can see for instance i saved it
and now i have to manually go back to
the dashboard it could have just saved
it and sent me back but no it doesn't do
that so app access is now crossed out as
you can see all right
let's go to the ad section so for the
ads we're gonna say no my app does not
contain ads okay press the save button
and then dashboard button
so that's for ads
and let's go ahead and take care of
content rating and this is kind of like
what we have to do for app store connect
as well in order to for instance say our
application doesn't contain violence it
doesn't contain
mature content etc so let's go to
content rating and say start
questionnaire
and let's just fill in our email address
so in here i'm just gonna
provide if i can spell support
at a pixelity
i have some problems right now
uh
support at pixelity
ab.sc and i believe yeah that's my
website so um
so i think that's that's the email i've
been using in app store connect as well
so uh let me also
just double check that in my notes so
i'm gonna bring this into a separate
website just i'm gonna check this in my
website um
and i think the
it is actually so i'm not using this
anymore so let's just pick some of the
appointments and here you just have to
enter your own email so don't enter my
email here so this is in case they need
as you can see if in case they need to
contact you so the category of our
application we say all other app types
because it's not a game or social or a
communication application so next
does the app contain any rating
ratings relevant content downloaded as
part of the app package
code or assets
no
and user accountant does the app
natively allow users to interact or
exchange content with other users
through the voice communication text no
then let's say
online content does the app feature
promote content that isn't part of the
initial app download but can be accessed
from the app no
promotion or sale of age restricted
products no miscellaneous does the app
share the user's current and precise
physical location nope
um does the app allow users to purchase
purchase digital goods no is the app a
web browser or search engine
no
is he a primarily a news or educational
product no okay so we save this
and we go to the next page summary and
you can see it says rating of 30 in
brazil all ages peggy 3
everyone can use this application rate
it for three plus
not sure to be honest with you with that
three plus
um
and then we could just say
submit all right
so
that part is done
seems like it and then we can we can
just go to our dashboard
okay and then let's go and take out our
target audience
and we say in here we choose 13
to 15 16 to 17 18 and over can also use
our application okay and this is kind of
like something you may decide on your
own whether like you you must add a
privacy policy target audience inclusion
or under 13 and that's why we're not
like targeting anybody under 13. and to
basically you may say oh my app's only
suitable for 18 and plus and that's
that's that's completely up to you and
you're more than welcome to do that but
i think our app is suitable even for 13
or even maybe less a 13 is quite a
basically like the sweet spot i would
say yeah because if you go lower than
that then you'll have to provide like
your privacy policy for those specific
targets so
we're not gonna do that
and then we're gonna press the next
button and let's have a look in here
what's asking us to do appeal to
children could your store listing
unintentionally
appear to children and we say yes
because
um we may not want this app to be
appearing for children but it may appear
nonetheless so let's just say yes there
and in here you can see the target group
is 13 to 18. so that's great now we
saved it and let's go back to our
dashboard and you can see here a target
audience is also
done
so let's go to the new section in here
news app is our app and news app and we
say no
all right and then we save and go back
and you can see that the news app stuff
is done
so let's now have a look at this covet
19 contact application and we say um
my app is not a publicly available code
with 19 contact tracing or status app so
save it and we say go back to dashboard
so that part of the application process
is also done
now we have to fill in the data safety
stuff so let's go through all of these
and
and this might take some time but that's
okay does your app collector share any
of the required user data types required
does your app collect or share any of
the required collect
required
user data types what do they mean
by required
personal information yeah we will
collect email addresses so yes of course
so let's just say yes
and
let's remove that is all of the user
data collected about your app encrypted
in transit yes and that's because we're
using firebase and that's using https so
that's encrypt in transit do you provide
a way for users to request that their
data is deleted no we don't do that and
i actually believe that it will be
really good if you did that
so if you are curious about this and if
you want to allow the user for instance
to be able to do that you could you
could check that out and see how you can
request
their data to be deleted you can create
a separate view for that for instance
and from there you can you can basically
make an api call to firebase and delete
this user so you could do that if you
want to okay and i may actually provide
a chapter
for that i don't know but at the moment
we say no
data types okay and let's have a look in
here this may take
a quite a long time so let's have a look
um
data types you must select any user data
that's are collected okay we're not
doing um location
personal information and we're
collecting email
personal identifier that relates to an
identifiable person for example an
account id account number or account
name yeah personal identifiers yeah
definitely
um
and other personal info we're not
collecting so we only have a user id and
an email address and that's it
and we're not even asking for their
names so
financial info no health no
messages
let's see what messages uh entails in
here where is it
where do you go here messages
emails no
photos and videos audio files files and
documents
um files and docs
a user's files or documents or any
information about a user's files or
documents for example file names yes
because we're storing actually their
files their notes so app activity no
contacts calendar no web browsing no
app info and performance no device or
other identifiers no so let's just then
press next there
and
not started so let's have a look at
start this email
process in here and we say select all
that apply is this data collected shared
or both it's only collected okay
and data collected in this way must
still be disclosed but will not be shown
to users on your store listing
is this data processed
ephemerally process family means that
the data is only stored in memory and is
retained for no longer than necessary so
no it is it is not stored only in the
memory so
and we say is this data required for
your application and in this case i
believe that we're talking about email
address and yes this data is required so
i'm just going to say yes it's required
why is the user data collected it's for
app functionality okay
so um
use for the setup and management of user
accounts actually yeah account
management so let's just say account
management so
um
and then press the save button so now
we've submitted the email address and
while we're why we're using that so
let's go to personal identifiers now and
start that process so we say we are only
collecting that
and because it's a user id and we're not
processing it ephemerally i think that's
how it's pronounced
and we say the data collection is
required and we say um it is used for
app functionality okay because we're
using the user identifier remember when
we store their notes so it's more for
app functionality than it is for
registration
so that's why we do that and that is
completed now so let's go to files and
docs and have a look at this process
files and docs and say
it is only collected but it is not
shared remember we are not sharing the
user's data even though we added that
sharing sheet for the user to share
their own information with someone else
but then that is their choice it is not
something that we are doing okay
is it then is this data processed
ephemerally then we say no and again i
don't know if that's the correct
pronunciation
and then is this data required for your
app and remember we're talking about
files and docs users can choose
whether this data is collected okay
because it is not something that we
force them to do okay
and why is this data
collected then we say it is for
advertising personalization
should i recommend it no account
management no so it is app functionality
we would say and we save it and that's
it so after you've done that we can just
go to the next screen and have a look at
this how it looks like you can actually
read about all the information that you
entered in here so
um and in here you can see at the bottom
of the screen says provide a link to
your privacy policy and and i have
already a privacy policy so i've um i
believe i have it in privacy policy text
so i'm gonna copy that and go to
privacy policy in here actually leave
and discard stay
um
so we may have to actually provide that
privacy policy i haven't yet done that
but we will have to do that
and
on the privacy policy page so yes we
need to we need to actually do that so
let's go ahead to um
i actually don't want let's save this as
draft and go here
and then enter the privacy policy in
here and i'm just going to say https
let's just make sure it's https yes and
save that okay then i'm going to go back
to the dashboard in here where we were
for data safety we were at the end of
this so let's go to uh next um
next next next at the bottom of this now
we have our privacy policy so now we can
save this and let's see if there's
anything that we have to do in order to
actually submit it so
it doesn't seem like it so it is
saved successfully so if we go back to
the dashboard and then have a look at
our data safety now we should be able to
see that it is crossed out so
that's fantastic
so um data safety is done and now we
have to have a look at this app category
and provide contact details okay
so let's go in here to app category and
we say it is an app and it's category
let's just say utilities if they're if
one exists in here
um let's just say it is a
what should we say
communication education events food
house library blah blah medical news
personalization productivity perhaps
okay and then tags let's just say
um oh this is
horrendous okay
um let's just say a note
notebook yeah let's just keep that okay
and you can choose more tags if you want
to
and
after that is done
let's see store listing contact details
and email address i'm just going to say
support app
pixelity.se phone number and i'm going
to enter some phone number in here
okay just a fake phone number for now
and https pixelity.se
external marketing
and
you may choose to advertise your
application outside of google play if
you want to and that's okay perhaps and
um before i save this i'm going to bring
the screen to another screen and
actually enter my real phone number okay
so i'm going to do that here let's see
if i can manage to do that
it doesn't really seem to like the fact
that i dragged it to another screen now
it likes it okay
so let me see
um uh
it really doesn't like that i'm dragging
it to my ipad so i'm gonna bring it to
my macintosh
yes and so all i'm doing here is just to
enter that information so let me bring
it up again
and then let's see if you can press the
save button okay so all i did is just
move the screen to another
physical screen enter my real phone
number and that was it
so
oops
stay safe your changes couldn't be saved
why not let me go and see if i
enter a valid oh i entered my phone
number incorrectly so i'm just gonna
save it
and scroll to the top of the screen
bring it back up
and then let's go to all apps okay
oops i want to go back to my app here
so in here we're done with the select
app category so that's fantastic
now it's the juicy part we have to set
up our store listing so um
this is also actually going to be quite
a an important part of the setup process
so this may actually take some time but
that's okay and we're gonna take care of
that in due time so now we have to look
at setting up our store listening and
the store listening um is one of the
absolute core components or and the core
things we have to do in order to be able
to release our applications so let's go
to set up your store listing in here and
let's put a short description and say
store
your notes securely
okay and a full description with this
application
and you can store your notes in the
cloud okay so and also i strongly
suggest that you write some proper
description for these things and it is
also very important if you remember that
we used an icon for our application and
that icon we
brought it from stock io so if you go in
here stock io and we use the sticky note
icon so it is important that in your
store description in both ios and
android you just say
um app icon provided by and just give
some attribution to that okay so it's
very very important that you read these
things and also give attributions where
attributions are due
so now we come to the application icon
section and you can see in here that
says the application icon should be five
twelve by five twelve and we don't have
that unfortunately at the moment what we
have is a thousand twenty four by
thousand twenty four so if we go back to
our downloads for instance in here
you'll see that we downloaded our app
icons in one of the earlier chapters and
we have this app store image in here
which i believe is thousand twenty four
thousand twenty four at the moment so
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna duplicate
this file command d on my macintosh on
windows and linux you may have to do
something else and if you have for
instance paint and paint
plus plus it's called paint.net or
something on windows you can also resize
your image but all you need to do is
just in your host operating system you
need to make sure that this image is
512512 so on the mac i'm just going to
click on here
it open on a separate screen and then
i'm going to go to tools and say adjust
size and i'm just going to say it is 5
12 5 12 okay
these are the guidelines so in here i'm
just going to drop that file right there
okay
okay so that's for your application icon
that's 5 12 5 12.
now we also need a it's a required feel
as you can see it is marked with an
asterisk in here and it's a future
graphing and future graphic is something
that a google play store can sometimes
use in for instance if your application
is featured on play store um
and they are going to use this image in
order to to basically um
do an advertisement for applications so
there are
guidelines for this and it should be you
can see it should be 1024x500
and since we don't have that we are
going to use our application icon in
order to create that future image so
what i think we should do is just to
open figma perhaps
and after our figma document is open
what we can do in here is to go and
create a little rectangle which was
1024x500 i believe the guidelines were
telling us to create it by so 1024 by
500 so i'm going to select this
rectangle and i say its width is 1024 by
and then height is 500 and what i like
to do is to go my trusty color palette
which is from a tokyo night
let's go to tokyo knight in here in
github as we've seen in previous
chapters i'm going to go scroll down a
little bit here and say that i have i
want the editor background color so it's
2428 3b and then i'm going to copy that
close the tab come here to figma and
change the fill color of this layer to
that so we're going to use this as our
background and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go to our downloads folder
and grab that app icon png
1024024 which we've downloaded in one of
the previous chapters so i'm gonna bring
it in here
then it is huge i'm gonna hold down the
shift key and then resize this
proportionally so kind of reset it to
something like this okay so i'm gonna
place it in the middle now i'm gonna
change the name of this to bg change the
name of this to icon by double clicking
on it and then i'm gonna create a text
field in here and save my awesome
notes
and let's
bring these into three separate lines
like that and let's also make sure that
the fill color of this is white also
ensure as you can see like mine
it is right aligned then i'm gonna place
it somewhere here okay in the middle as
well and perhaps we could even increase
the size of the font so let's see what
we have here we have about 200 let's say
120 and it is a little bit bigger a
little bit bolder in your face kind of
stuff so and this is our text so this is
our text what i'm going to do in here
then is i'm going to
um
basically take these like bg icon and
text and then duplicate this bg in here
because this is going to be our mask i'm
going to grab grab it and bring it at
the bottom then i'm going to right click
it and say use as mask and now it has
its own group then i'm going to grab all
of these three layers and then drag them
here and now you can see that that mask
is basically masking off this entire
content so it's masking off our icon as
well so it looks pretty good to me it's
kind of proportional it's nice so then
you can click on this
and then in figma go to the bottom so if
i change the
um in here so you can see better perhaps
then scroll so make sure your mask group
is selected then go to export and then
we're gonna export it as one x and then
that is exported now so now we have our
image looking like this and it is
1024x500 so we can go to uh
our play console google play console and
right where we have to uh throw this
feature graphic i'm going to go to
downloads and the image that we just
downloaded which is right here i'm gonna
just drop it in there
so then that is working fine as well and
then i'm gonna
save my changes and something is wrong
with our changes some languages have
errors okay
that's probably because we haven't
really uploaded any screenshots yet and
we're gonna take care of that soon so it
is a little bit um
strange that it doesn't let me just let
me save my changes as a draft i have to
save this entire screen and since i
haven't entered some of the information
in the screen which is required it's not
allowing me to actually save it so but
we're gonna take care of that soon so um
what we need to do in here is to ensure
that we're first running our latest
application on the correct phone as well
so
let's see in here i'm going to bring our
source code in here and then i'm going
to say select the device and then i'm
going to choose my android phone all
right so
that's that then i'm going to actually
grab my android phone let's see if i can
do it without causing too much problem
here on the screen like that
and authenticated
great
make sure it is connected to wi-fi as
well
fantastic so
my android phone is now set up
and let's then go ahead in our source
code let me change some
screen layout in here
in our source code then i'm going to go
to main dark file if i can spell
dart file and in here in our terminal
i have two terminals so one i usually
dedicate here to um
scr cpy so i'm just going to say scr cpy
and that's going to bring up the android
phone up right there and since we've
selected that we can now just say run
without debugging so the goal in here is
to run the application on this
particular android phone
and have sdrcpy take screenshots for us
as you'll soon see so there's a really
good command called adb and adb is like
the low level and low level android
debugger
and by using adb you can actually
communicate with your
you know for instance your emulators
android emulators and your android
phones
as we have here so
if you don't have adb you will actually
have to install it so if i say which adb
on my computer you can see that it says
it's homebrew bin adb basically telling
you that i've installed adb using
homebrew
if you haven't a if you don't have adb
on your computer you may need to install
it if if what you're also doing is
following along with the steps that i'm
providing you meaning that you're taking
trying to take a screenshot with
from an actual device that is connected
to your computer okay so i can see now
that our application is running in scr
cpy looking like this so what we could
do is to issue the command as you saw so
let's just go ahead and say
um adb exec
exec out screen cap key and then we save
it into for instance file1.png
and if i have a look in visual studio
code you'll soon see now there is a file
stored here file1png and that is that
file with the screenshot of our
application
and then we can go to another screen for
instance the i forgot my password screen
in here
and we could also send our keyboard down
kind of look like this and then we can
issue another one
file to png so that's stored as well
let's go to the registration screen and
send the keyboard down and then let's
say file three png and also sending the
keyboard down or up or leaving it up it
is it is a it is a taste thing it is
completely up to you how you want to do
it okay so in here i'm going to go here
vandal mp
and actually log in with a real user
and go to the main screen of the
application i'm gonna take file for png
and then i'm going to go to one of my
notes in here with the keyboard up
perhaps in this case and then say file
five png okay
and then i'm gonna say open so i'll see
all my png files in here then i'm going
to take those files and bring them to
desktop so they're not polluting the
workspace here in visual studio code
let's go back in here and you can see
that you can just drop drop
two phone or tablet screenshots in there
so
let's go ahead to my desktop folder
where i stored all those screenshots and
just drop all those images in here okay
and i can see them populated here i'm
gonna grab the login screen and see if
it can actually bring it first and
unfortunately here it's not allowing me
to drop things at the right order so
unfortunately i have to delete them and
like drop them at the right order so
file one first
and then i have to upload file too so it
is a little bit um strange that it
doesn't let me re
rearrange these images
but perhaps there is a functionality for
that that i don't know about
so let's then say file four
and then we have to upload file five as
well okay
so that's there as well
um
okay
so that's that then what we need to take
care of now is to create a five inch
tablet and since i don't have a five
inch tablet here sitting around as a
physical device then we have to go and
create one so if we look at um here
visual studio code and go to flutter
select device you'll see that there are
various um
basic um
tablets that i've created with
my device manager with
android studio so if you have android
studio you can always open it and
android studio um
oh
oh it did open it anyway so it's right
here you can always go i believe into um
avd manager which is the virtual device
manager and then create your virtual
device as you can see you need to create
a file is this seven inch and a 10.1
inch tablet because we're going to take
screenshots with these so what i'm going
to do actually is to launch both of
these tablets so that they're ready to
go when we need them so that's the first
tablet and i'm actually going to
turn it around so it is in the portrait
mode so that's that one and then i'm
also going to ask
avd manager here to run a second tablet
in here and that was extremely fast i
saw i don't even know how it did that
how could it run this tablet so fast a
little bit scary to be honest so
now that's sitting there um
let's see if it's gonna do its work
correctly though i can see the seven
inch tablet is not doing so well let's
see if i can close it and i'm gonna say
yes close so perhaps i should have i'm
going to shut this one down
and don't know if we're going to
actually be better off first running the
7-inch tablet and see if that is
successful
maybe something happened in the
processing of the 10 inch as well as the
7 inch i don't really know
it is completely up to
the device manager here
and i can see that this device isn't
really doing so well so i press the
power button on it here and i can see
now it is running so i'm going to press
the home button
and um orientation isn't really working
so well here
so i can see that
now maybe it's working a little bit
better so let's just leave it at that so
that's the seven inch display and it is
up and running then what i'm going to do
and the flutter daemon has terminated
that's completely fine reload it
then what we're going to do is to say
select device in here
flutter select the vibe and that's
probably because the flutter demon
actually crashed on us here so i'm gonna
try one more time and if it doesn't work
then i'm going to quit visual studio
code so
let me start visual studio code and
fresh
okay now that visual studio started
fresh let's just try again and say
flutter select device and this time i'm
going to choose a 7-inch
android tablet then i'm going to say run
without debugging so let's see if we're
going to have any success running this
application in this tablet
and if gradle build
is working well for us today then it's
going to allow us to do lse performing
stream install failed to install
launching application and sdk g phone 64
rm64 so there could be some problem with
this android tablet in here so i'm going
to close that
and i'm going to go back to android
studio if i can't find it somewhere here
let's see android
studio
okay it's running now
and let's go in here then i'm going to
go to avd manager
and let's have a look if we can close
these and kill these two tablets
completely like that like that
and while i'm at it i'm also going to
kill this one so i don't have any use
for that so i'm going to create a new
virtual device then i'm going to say
excuse me a tablet that is nexus 7 and 7
inch display
something like this
that is fine and it's thousand 200 by
nineteen twenty so what is required here
from us it says
uh
seven inch tablet screenshots okay
that's fantastic so it doesn't have
specific size requirements and then i'm
gonna press next on s
is absolutely fine
that is fine as well on portrait and
then i'm going to say finish
then let's see if he can run this
emulator on this computer
and if everything goes fine we're going
to see the welcome screen here i can see
google's logo so that's a great sign
always and i'm going to keep the screen
here just in case
and while that is doing its work we're
going to go back to
flutter and i can see the emulator is up
now and i'm going to say select device
and i'm going to choose it here let's
then say run run without debugging and
see hopefully this time we have better
luck in running that application in the
given emulator so let's see
wow that went really fast actually it
went surprisingly fast so now it's
running in there and i can see our
application running in the emulator so
what we need to do in here is to
actually take some screenshots so um
when we need all you see here actually
we all have to provide 7-inch tablet
screenshots and we also have to fix the
10-inch tablet screenshot but what i
want to mention is
depending on the size of the screen at
the moment you can see everything is
working fine there's not a problem you
can go to register screen i also forgot
my password and all of these are working
quite fine however
we have a scrolling problem
and i can see in here that the seven
inch display i've mentioned at the
bottom of the screen that the seven inch
display could actually block the view
and that could be for instance because
um now in in this case is not actually
blocking the view but if you had a
smaller screen it could block the view
in that this screen as you can see is
not scrollable so if you had a smaller
screen then this keyboard could pop on
top of the content that you have in here
blocking the content so what we need to
do before we start taking some
screenshots from our android um tablet
let's go and fix these things up
let's first go to our verify email view
in our application oops i press the
launch button again by mistake sorry
about that i'm going to stop this
let's go to and verify email view and
you'll see in the code that the verify
email view state at the moment's return
is scaffold and it has a column in order
for this column to be vertically
scrollable all you have to do is just
wrap it with a widget and just say
single child
world view as the notes indicate at the
bottom of the screen okay so that's the
scrolling down for that let's now go to
the login view so login view and wrap
the entire content in here in this
column and let's say wrap it with
a widget okay and i'm going to say
single child
scroll view just like that okay
and i changed the screen layout a little
bit so you see the code better let's
then go to our register view as well so
register view and on top of the screen
we have the scaffold and a column so
let's also in this column say wrap it
with a widget of single child scroll
view alright and last but not least
we're gonna go to our forgot password
view and have a look at how we're
creating the screen we have a scaffold
padding column just like a standard
we've done in other places as well wrap
with widget in a single child
scroll view all right so that's that now
that we've done that we're actually
ready to launch this application again
so select device to nexus and then i'm
going to say run without debugging all
right so what we need to do now is to
use adb again the low level debugger for
android but this time we want to take
screenshots of an emulator as you saw in
the previous uh
section when we talked about taking
screenshots of an actual android phone
running in scr cpy we had to use adb as
well but we didn't have to tell it that
it is an emulator as you can see at the
bottom of the screen now if you specify
an e flag to adb then that indicates the
adb that you want to take a screenshot
of an emulator okay so
here's that device running
excuse me our application
and what we need to do now is to go to
command line and let me just do some
reshuffling on the screen
and this is our
scrcpy and i'm gonna just do some screen
shuffling here so get rid of this
let's go to terminal
okay so
let's issue the command as you can see
at the bottom of the screen so
i'm gonna do like this
and uh like that so
adb exit out but before that i'm just
gonna say dash e and screen cap
e and then let's say file
one png all right so
and if i now go to the project structure
i can see there is a file called file
one png and it is a screenshot from our
emulator okay so i'm gonna re
do the same thing i'm gonna go to forgot
my password screen and um let's get up
and get rid of the keyboard in here and
let's remove that space that i just
entered and then take the second
screenshot as file to png
and then let's go to the login page and
the register page get rid of this
keyboard
file free png okay so now that we have
that oops i'm going to
i press the back button i'm going to
log into our application with my email
address and our
horrible password of foo barb ads now
we're in the application let's take a
fourth screenshot called file for png
and in here while this is up with the
keyboard perhaps as well
let's see
and then take screen shot 5 or file 5
png so now we have 5 screenshots from
our 7 inch display as well
let's
excuse me let's go and collect those
screenshots file one two five and then
i'm gonna delete the ones on desktop and
just cut and paste the ones from
our application then let's go to
um
our google play console in here in the
seven inch display i'm gonna drop these
one by one so
drop the file one in here
and then let's drop file two right after
that and then we can say file three four
and five
so i uh so that you know how um i'm
thinking about the ordering of the
screenshots okay
so that's file four and then we have
file five right there and what we need
to do is we need to basically do the
same thing for as
a 10 inch display as you can see here it
says 10 inch tablet screenshot so let's
go again
now we can close this emulator that is
right there then we can go back to
android studio so if i can find android
studio here
okay let's go to avd manager and in here
we're going to create a new virtual
device in this case it's going gonna say
tablet and in a nexus 10
is a 10 inch display i'm going to press
next and then sdk s that's fine as well
and just run it ooh landscape not sure
about that but
that's that may be fine but you know
what i'm actually going to delete it and
create a new one because we had some
problem before with the landscape mode
so i'm going to say nexus 10 again next
next portrait and then finish okay so
hopefully this starts it in the portrait
mode so then i'm gonna press the play
button right there and unfortunately it
started in the landscape mode but that's
okay hopefully we're gonna be able to
rotate it around
and i can see now it is running
hopefully uh so like that
and we should see now the home screen
let's see if we can rotate this uh
and unfortunately it doesn't actually
rotate so i want to see if there's any
properties in here that allows us to
change the display
from landscape to portrait so
snapshots recording settings enabled
light proxy advanced
show window frame
nope nothing in there that allows us to
change this device from
um
directional pad no it doesn't change the
display from
landscape to portrait and i am now
basically trying anything i can so even
if i go to chrome in here for instance
and say no thanks and then if i rotate
this i can see that it's unfortunately
not rotating the actual application so
we might then have to
take a screenshot in landscape mode so
let's see if if you can actually do that
so if there's anybody out there who
knows how to fix this issue i'd be
grateful to also know
because at the moment even doing the
command right and left it's not
listening to my commands it's not
basically rotating so how about this
icon
um well that didn't help so so much to
be honest with you so
um
it didn't really i mean i can go here
and then here oh now it's portrait okay
i did something so i just clicked on a
little icon on the top left after
rotating so it rotated to portrait so
that was just pure luck
let's go to visual studio code and say
command shift p on a macintosh or ctrl
shift p in linux and windows and save
flash or select device choose our 10
inch display
then i'm going to say run run without
debugging and if
everything is working correctly and
gradle's working in our favor then then
the gradle task is going to go by really
fast and i'm very grateful actually for
that to be honest
so gradle is working a lot better now
than xcode build process so here's our
application and displayed on a 10 inch
display and let's go ahead and start
taking some screenshots so i'm going to
go to terminal here and then start
taking screenshots of
file one in the login view then let's go
to forgot password and say
file two i'm gonna get rid of the
keyboard and take the screenshot without
the keyboard i'm gonna go here to the
register view get rid of the
keyboard and then say file three so
that's that let's not log in with a user
um like this and say foobar baz
log in with that user oh wrong
credentials okay
uh foo barbaz
login
and after logging in we're going to take
another screenshot which is our
screenshot 4 and then we're going to
take another screenshot with the
keyboard and for our um
file 5. all right so
that is also that then i'm going to open
the current folder i can see five
screenshots in here go to my desktop get
rid of the old ones and paste the new
ones in there
okay now that we have those we can clean
and remove this
emulator we don't have it and i'm also
going to close avd i can see it's
already closed so let's go back to
um our play store in here
so and play store um
console so i'm gonna upload
this new um png file file one then file
two for the ten inch tablet so all of
these five screenshots are for the ten
inch tablet
three
and then we're gonna go to four here
and then last but not least we're gonna
upload screenshot five and then right
after the upload is done i'm just going
to delete all those files to keep my
desktop clean so after doing that let's
just then save this and now you can see
it says your changes have been saved
fantastic
so now that is done and
we need to create a release app so if i
just bring my notes up a little bit here
fantastic so
what we need to do we need to have a
look at a little url here as you can see
at the bottom of the screen it's called
docslatter dev deployment android it is
a very important document and here i
strongly suggest anybody who's trying to
create a release application to go
through this it has information for
windows and macintosh and linux users
and these commands are absolutely um
full of value so
you may have to google these otherwise
around but this document has really put
all of that together in the same place
so as you can see in here the first
thing that we need to do is to create a
signing key for our application
and you need to follow these um
commands in here that have been created
for you so you can see and if i bring a
terminal up so if i say
terminal and i'll bring it up here and
if i go to this folder dot android on my
computer like this and i already have
some keys as you can see in here so i
have some keys already set up but in
order for us to actually
um
be able to follow along with this
and guide we need to go and create these
keys for us as well okay so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to do
let's see if i can bring up the command
for you as you can see at the bottom of
the screen so i'm going to actually copy
that command that i provided for you at
the bottom of the screen okay
so and i'm going to go to terminal and
um let's just go to desktop for instance
and then i'm going to issue that command
exactly as you can see at the bottom of
the screen so let's see what happens in
here now it says enter a key store
password so this is a password that you
need to then provide inside a property
file i'll tell you soon about it so
remember this password up until this
point for this course we've been using
foobar baz as a password is an
absolutely horrible password so please
don't use that but since we've used it
consistently in this course and since
the password in this sense has no
meaning for this course i'm just going
to say foo bar pass but please don't use
a password as weak as that so
let's say foo barbaz
and let's see what it said java as a
keystore was tampered with or password
was incorrect so
um it this could perhaps be because i'm
actually trying to create an upload key
store like this and i already have one
from before so what i'm going to do is
to actually delete this file so i'm
going to say remove that file okay
upload keystore like that and i'm going
to issue this command again and i'm
going to say foo bar house
and fubarba so if you if you've already
had a key store from before then you
could just use it but i'm assuming that
you didn't have one however when i did
issue this command i already had one so
chances are you didn't have a keystore
from before you didn't you didn't have
to delete it but in my case i actually
have to delete it first and then issue
the command that you can see in the
caption at the bottom of the screen so
what is your first and last name i'm
just going to save and i have andy poor
okay
and your organization unit i'm just
going to say development
and then name of your organization is
pixelity a b okay city or locality okay
i can just say stockholm okay
and state or okay stockholm again let's
see uh two letter country code i'm gonna
say s e and it is saying is it correct
then i'm gonna press the enter button
uh i've already entered all of that
maybe i made a mistake in here so let's
just say what was the question
correct no do i have to type yes i'm
just going to say yes so
you have to provide yes at the end of
that and then what is the same return if
same as keystore password yes just enter
okay so now it's created a key store
for us in here you can see in the
android folder upload keystore jks okay
so that's very very important
now that that has been created what we
need to do is to have if you had
followed this you can see that what we
need to do now is to go to our flutter
project in here you see it says go to
your flutter project
and
and go to the android folder and create
a file called key dot properties okay so
let's go ahead and create that so i'm
going to open visual studio code in here
and then i'm going to go to cd
and let's see where we are at the moment
we're in the
root folder of our project standard
project i'm gonna go to the android
folder as it was suggested there and
then i'm gonna create a new file as it
was called here key dot properties okay
so key dot properties like this and then
i'm gonna
paste that content that was mentioned
here as you can see
like that
so maybe the entire content so i'm just
gonna paste it in here okay so it says
password for previous step from previous
step and we just said fubar bass
like that and the key password as well
and again that is foo bar bass the key
alias we're going to leave it as upload
and in here we're going to say the file
was stored in let's see if you can get
the entire path for this so it's right
here so i'm going to copy that path path
sorry and then i'm going to delete this
information in here and then paste it
right there okay
so that should be good to go so i'm just
gonna double check in my notes as well
that that is how we've done it before as
well and that seems to be completely
fine so
then after doing that with an empty line
at the end i'm going to close this file
and save its contents right there so now
if you go to the main folder of your
application and say git status then you
should see that you
have only these things basically
committing to your project because your
key properties are not going to be
committed okay
so
and that's that's why i'm mentioning
here that you always need to make sure
that that particular file is not going
to be committed with your project into
github so you could always go to your
git ignore file and actually add that
particular file to your ignore so let's
just say veeam git ignore
not get ignore and in here we're just
going to add a new file and say any
key.properties file should not be
committed and then we do a good status
again that our get ignore is changed if
you're paranoid like me you will do it
like i did all right
so after doing that what we need to do
is to in fact create basically
um
sorry we have to update our build gradle
for signing and
i provide a link which i'm going to go
to myself and let's see um
if i can find that
link myself
configure signing in gradle and that is
right here uh here
and it is telling us exactly what to do
it says add the keystore information
from your properties file before the
android block you see this android block
in here so what we need to do is to go
to this file in our project android app
build gradle so visual studio code
let's go to um build.gradle in android
app all right so we're there and what
did it say that we have to find this
section android you see
so let's find the android block right
there it's just one so right there then
let's copy this text as it is mentioned
there and paste it right before android
okay boom and i'm going to bring it one
step
back as well so it is
um
basically formatted correctly okay so
that's that part and it says then load
the key.properties file into the
keystore properties object and that's
what this guy is doing okay then what we
need to do it says find the build types
block so let's go and find that you can
see the release we're gonna basically
edit that as well so i'm gonna go to my
notes as well build gradle uh sorry
about that just to ensure that i'm
following all the steps correctly
and in here it says release to do add
your own signing config for the release
build signing with the debug key for now
so flutter run release works and it says
then replace that with this so you just
have to grab this information here and
just completely replace this build types
with that thing that was provided i'm
gonna fix the uh indentation a little
bit as well so here the key alias
password are being read from the correct
place and then the release is signed
with the release key in here
and that is it really so you don't have
to do so much more and what we're gonna
do now is to as you can see at the
bottom of the screen we're gonna do some
cleaning up of the um of the build
artifact so in your project you need to
now go to terminal here as you can see
for on my screen so i'm just going to go
and say flutter clean
okay
so like that
all right
and we're then going to say flutter
pub
get
all right
and after doing that we're actually
going to
um create our app bundle so after doing
flutter pop get then you have to issue
flutter build app bundle
so by issuing this command you can see
now it is going to start building your
application with griddle using all those
properties that you've specified in
those various files so there was a lot
of work that we have to do but
thankfully it's been documented so well
that it makes the whole process so much
easier had it not been for all those
documentation bits and pieces it would
have been such a difficult process to go
through so let's just wait for this
build gradle process to now do its work
and all right now you can see that the
process has gone through it has created
our little app bundle which is this aab
file
and what we need to do is to be able to
then upload this app bundle to google
play store so let's go back to our play
store and here i'm going to close this
close figma
and let's now go back to our dashboard
in here
and you can see my awesome notes and
let's see what we have
going on in here and what we need to do
is to go to our production in here and
and then create a new release okay so
press the create new new release in
there and you can see now it asks you to
upload your app bundle so what i'm going
to do is to go back to visual studio
code and see where this file is located
so i'm going to open that folder and i
can see the aab here and i'm going to
then drag it in here and place it there
okay
so
after this upload is done it may take
some time i can see it's 25 megabytes
although i'm at a thousand thousand line
um fiber optic network in here it's
taking like a while to upload i don't
know really why
but in the release name as you can see
it says that well this is not something
um that we actually share with anybody
so let's just say um first we call it
first version okay so and in here for
your release notes you will basically
copy from a previous release well we
don't have that listen here just say um
the first
version of our app okay
and then we can save this information
all right so
excuse me
so now we have that um we have the first
version in there okay
and
that should be it so let's just go to
the review release in here and we have
one error that's probably because we
haven't provided the countries
and add at least one country or region
and that's fine we're gonna we're gonna
add that so let's go and see
overview where we have to add these
countries if we can't figure it out
somehow
let's click in there android okay
that is fine
and um
we need to go to under production and
all the countries or release as you can
see in google play a console under
production so i believe we're already
under production so if i click under
production now we can see countries and
regions so let's go in there and say add
countries and regions and i believe we
could in here
hopefully select all countries
if you
sell such good make sure your price for
the countries well can we not sell oh
yeah i i saw that
if i click here i can select all the
countries so let's do that and say add
countries and regions and then press the
add button fantastic
then we're gonna go to our releases
and uh
here
we have this release so let's go to the
release dashboard
okay that's fine and then i'm gonna
press the edit release
and i'm gonna press the review release
now that we've selected all those
countries we have one warning the app
bundle contains native code and if
you've not uploaded debug symbols okay
and these debug symbols is something
that i actually encourage you to go read
about because these are gonna allow you
to see when whenever and if there is any
crashes in your application occurring
anywhere
where your users are using your
application so
i would really suggest that you do this
and upload your d box symbols although
that's something that i believe is
outside the scope of this course but it
should be quite straightforward for you
to figure it out and there's link in
here that you can read more about it
so now we can start the rollout to
production and then say rollout
and you'll see now this is going to go
in review and
and google uh cons like at the play
console could take some while some time
to rel to review the first version of
our application some people said it
takes upwards of a week and for me it's
some sometimes actually taking about
eight nine days so
depending on what you've done like that
your track record from before if you
release any applications from before you
may actually be able to be placed
somewhere first in the queue or maybe
last i don't know i don't know their
processes so
um and that that was really in that was
like the releasing of our android
application and we went through quite a
lot even figma design in the middle of
everything so congratulations for going
through this together with me
since we've changed some code let's go
ahead and
um actually commits all our changes so
i'm going to say good status
and make sure that your
properties file the key properties file
is not added so let's just say git add
all
and then i'm going to say git commit
step
and if you have a look at our logs we
have step 30 and 31 so let's push those
changes to our remote and then i'm going
to say get a tag also step 31
okay
and get push tags
so
that was it now you've released your
application for ios and android and um
this this could perhaps be the last
thing that you will um learn about in
this course right now as it is if you're
one of the early adopters of this course
but i'm planning on putting out a lot
more videos that i'm going to append to
this course with a lot more material so
stay tuned and i may actually see you in
the next chapter hello everyone and
welcome to this chapter in the previous
chapters as you've been following along
with this
course you know that we've created our
application and we've also released it
to the app store
for ios and also google's play store
using a play store console
and now you will
i mean any application or any software
is not something that you will do and
it's just finished every application has
to live on and there will be you will
add new functionalities to it and then
um you kind of have to keep it alive
just as i will keep this course live
you'll also have to keep your
application alive so one of the things
that you might want to add to your
application is localization
now um
if you don't know
i mean if you haven't done software
development before you may not know what
localization is but
localization in um short form is the
process of you making your application
more accessible to other people in
different countries
than the one for instance that um
you live in so
up until this point we've been creating
our application with a user interface
that is mainly in english
but you may not be even from england you
may not be from australia or us you may
just speak the language english
and um for instance i live in sweden so
the application that we have developed
right now isn't really accessible to
everyone in sweden
even though most people in sweden speak
very fluent english however it's not
their mother tongue so
localization is um the process of making
your application more accessible to
those people who don't speak the
language that you've designed for your
user interface
and it's not just
about the language and the text that
you're using it also entails a lot of
other and also
includes many other things for instance
how you
present
currency and values in your application
now we don't have like a shopping basket
or anything we don't have an e-commerce
application and that we've developed so
far so there's nothing for the user to
purchase in the application but
um
if you were developing an application
where the user could for instance buy
things then
your shopping basket would need to for
instance present
the amount um for um like the product
prices in
in that person's
currency so if you're for instance
presenting the ui to a person in sweden
that person doesn't expect to see for
instance prices in dollars they would
expect to see prices in the swedish
crown
and um or if for instance you're doing
this application for someone in
england you'd probably want to do
with gbp which is the great
british pound i think or just pound
so
localization is a lot more than just
changing the text of our application but
since our application doesn't have any
of those things we're not presenting any
dates for instance at the moment we're
not presenting
any currencies or values like that then
for us it in it basically means only
changing the text of our application
so what we're going to do in this
chapter is going to
localize our application
and
we're going to do it in two languages so
for english which we've already done so
far which is the text that we've
provided for the user interface of the
application to this point and we're also
going to do it in swedish now you don't
have to know swedish in order to be able
to go through this chapter i'm going to
help you with that and there's a github
repository for this project that you can
just copy and paste
the swedish text for instance
you don't have to even write swedish at
all you don't even have to follow along
writing the exact text that i'm writing
for instance in swedish you can just put
some gibberish in there because
all you have to do really is just to
understand the concepts of what
localization entails for your
application how you can do it with
flutter and then when it comes to
actually localizing your own
applications then you can for instance
choose um bangladeshi or if you want to
choose any language in india for
instance or um or do if in pakistan or
whatever um
language you choose to basically go for
so you don't have to really know swedish
that's what i'm that's what i'm saying
but
um also as you can see at the bottom of
the screen localization could also be
for languages that are not traditionally
left right like farsi or
um arabic so those languages are written
right to left so
there will need to be some special
considerations made into um
code for you if you're trying to support
right to left languages like for c
and um
so for instance a name of a person
um
you may want to be able for instance if
you're presenting a list of famous
people
that for instance the user can read
about those names may not have to
necessarily be
um presented in arabic names like
they're like their spelling doesn't
necessarily have to be arabic it could
be english but
for instance an age of a person like if
you were saying bill gates you could
write the name in english even though
the language of user user interface is
arabic but the age of that person if
you're presenting then it might need to
be translated in like um numerical
values that are under understood by
whoever speaks that language
so um
what i'm trying to say is that if you're
trying to support right-to-left
languages you may have to take into
consideration those points that i just
mentioned but in this chapter we're not
going to do that we're just going to
cover english and swedish and those both
languages are left to right
now let's have a look at
the documentation because the
documentation for localization of a
fluster application is very thorough
and i highly suggest that after watching
this chapter and learning about it
from my perspective i think it is very
very important that you actually have a
look at the um
the official become documentation i'll
try to open with a tab in here so um
i'll bring it to the screen so you'll
see
so i'll get rid of that
and i'll bring up
the
screen a little bit like this sorry i
have to do some rearrangement so you see
the screen better so as you can see here
it's an official documentation for
accessibility localization and
international internationalization
and
um
you'll see some terms sometimes for
instance and during internationalization
and localization you'll see some terms
such as i 18 n
and sometimes you'll also see l 10 n and
you'll be wondering like what are these
things what does it even mean l 10 n
and the reason for like what i 18n
actually means it is
internationalization
um and if you look at it
internationalizes
if i write it
the asian like this
and then if you take 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
one two three four five six seven eight
so 18 total number of characters between
i and n
so it is known then to write i 18 n just
to refer to internationalization
and the same thing is true for
localization because let's let's bring
up for instance visual studio code
maybe we can actually see in visual
studio code a little bit better
um if i bring it up here
and i
increase the size of the font
and if i write enter
nationalized international
international non-lineation
okay and then write localization so that
was one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten one two three four five
six seven eight so it's 18 total and if
we look at localization between l and n
if you count it one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten characters so
a lot of people refer to these things as
i18n and l10n i18n basically means
internationalization and l10n means
localization so now you know the reason
for that it's just it's just programmers
being lazy and trying to like shorten
everything as much as they can so now if
you see these two terms then you know
what they refer to
okay so what i was saying basically in
the beginning is to please after
watching this video go ahead and read
the official documentation because it is
very important it's very thorough it
talks about things that we don't even
talk about in this chapter
so um i
highly recommend that you read this
documentation as well
okay
so that was that and now what we need to
do is to basically get started by adding
um internationalization localization
support to our flutter application so
i'm gonna bring bring a visual studio
code in here and maybe decrease the size
a little bit
i'm gonna change the screen layout all
right so
um this is how we've left our
application to this point so what we
need to do is i'm just gonna close all
the tabs and then i'm going to press
command and command p in visual studio
to open a file for instance
and then we're going to look at our pop
spec yaml file so
if you go there and what we need to do
is to add flutter localizations to our
pop special
let's have a look in here and you can
see and you may be actually wondering
why i'm
what am i even talking about what is
flutter um
localizations and i didn't make that up
it is basically documented right here
let's have a look at it
as you can see it says the first thing
that we need to do is to go to our pop
spec yaml file and add flutter
localizations now
what this basically does for our
application is that it allows
our application to be
localized and it also adds uh like
auto-generated code for our application
as you'll soon see so
it is a little bit difficult to explain
exactly what it does before you've seen
the results so what we need to do for
now is just to find the dependencies
section of our pop specky ammo here and
i found it here and what we need to do
in as you can see it says you just need
to add flutter localizations and i'm
going to do that right after flutter
okay and a column
and then we're going to say sdk flutter
all right so that's that and this
application at the moment is not running
so what i'm gonna do is just to say
um select device and then i'm going to
use my android phone okay as you follow
along with the with the course you know
that i
prefer personally to have
real devices running so right now i have
um scr cpy i think somewhere let's see
if we can bring it up actually let's go
to terminal
scr cpy
so this is
my android telephone
and then on the side i also have an
actual iphone running here so
basically there are two devices and that
have our app installed um so an iphone
and an android and we're going to work
with both of them
um
so um what we're gonna do is to run our
application uh on the android phone for
instance i'm gonna say command shift p
on uh when
on mac and then ctrl shift b on a linux
machine or windows and then say select
device and i'm going to select this
android phone then i'm going to go to
the main dart file and then just say run
without debugging so let that do its job
i'm going to decrease the font a little
bit because it's just humongous at the
moment so after doing that after adding
the pop specky ammo in here we also need
to make sure that we follow the
as you can see in here it says yeah you
have to do these things and we're going
to take care of that
but what we're also going to do is to
add this internationalization package to
our application so let me remove that
screen from there make sure that our
android application is running and this
is the state i've left the application
i'm logged in at the moment so what i'm
going to do is just to log out
all right so that up until this point
the only thing we did really was to add
flutter localization sdk true sorry sdk
flutter here then what we need to do is
to add the internationalization package
to our application okay so let's go and
i'm going to open a new terminal in here
in visual studio code and change the
layout a little bit so you see it better
as well like this
and let's just go ahead and say flutter
pop add intel okay
and you can read more about this intel
package on popdev so if we for instance
go to create a new tab in here and i
bring it here and we just say puff.dev
and let me increase the size
to a little bit more ginormous size
and let's just say intl okay and you can
see here's the intl package
and it is from darkdev so it is actually
an official package that you can include
in your application and there's
documentations about how to use it okay
so you can also see how you can for
instance um handle date formatting in
different languages all right so now
we've added that and if i bring this
screen like this so you can see the
results of adding that package to our
application and i can see
it says got dependencies all right so
that was the result of saying flutter
pop at intel
fantastic the other thing that we need
to do is to
go under flutter here
in our pop spec if i change the screen
layout a little bit more
um we need to go as you can see at the
bottom of the screen we need to add a
generate true under the flutter section
and it is right here so this generates
true that we add just like this it is um
it is
very very important basically for how
code generation is gonna work
so i'm gonna basically have a look here
generate and add space here okay so if
you add this generate true in here it
allows the localization packages and
like the localization code that is
running in your application to generate
to auto generate
code for you what i mean by that is as
you'll soon see
flutter internally uses a
file called a file type called marb
and these arb files are kind of like key
value
files and very i mean kind of like json
and in the keys um you specify some
names for instance you say login screen
title
and the value would then be the actual
value you've translated in that specific
language
and you will have multiple of these arb
files
and i think actually i'm going to
explain it rb more soon but it stands
for application resource bundle
but just know that
i mean i don't want to go too much into
details about arb files right now
because there's a section coming up
where i'll explain that but what you
need to know right now is that this
generate true flag under your flutter
section in pop special allows
the auto generated code to basically
hook itself into your project and when
you add new keys and values to your arb
files as you'll soon see how
then up then the code generation will
kick in every time you do a hot restart
or you run your application fresh and it
will go through your arb files and it
will generate the keys
in
inside like a dart
um source code for you
and this dart source code will be
something that you can literally import
into your application and like use the
keys you added to the json as just like
dart code inside your application
so this is a lot of talking just like
abstract talking but you will soon see
exactly how these things work so don't
worry about that
so what we need to do now is after we've
done all this work we need to basically
add support for localization into our
ios application as you can see at the
bottom of the screen in the caption now
android works just automatically in that
when we start adding localization to our
application new languages the android
app just completely understands then
okay here's a new language i can handle
that and i will just refresh my
ui in order to display all the values
that you entered but ios is a little bit
more old-fashioned you have to help it
understand that this application
actually supports various languages
so and i'm actually glad to say that you
don't have to have xcode in order to go
through this particular
section of this chapter
but we need to as you can see at the
bottom of the screen we have to go to
our info plist file and update a special
section or create a special section
called core foundation bundle
localizations okay so let's go ahead and
actually take care of that right now so
i'm gonna also bring up my notes to
ensure that i'm telling you all
everything that i plan to tell you
see if i can find that section
all right
so what i'm going to do in here i'm
going to close that file i'm also going
to close the main dar file and then i'm
going to press command p in visual
studio code and i'm going to look for a
file called info.plist it should be
under the ios folder slash runner and in
there there's an info p list and if
you're curious exactly where that is you
will be able to for instance go to
terminal and i'm gonna clean the
terminal and i'm just gonna say open you
can see this is the folder where
this entire course source code is based
if i say open
okay so we're gonna open as you can see
in here
so
this is the source code where we we are
at the moment and there is a folder
called ios and in there there's a a
folder called runner and in there
there's a file called info plist so
that's where
that's the file that we have to open
right now okay
so i'm going to say command p again and
then info plist let's open that and
these are like key values as you can see
it's it's a strange like p list kind of
like an xml format kind of thing
but you will need to look for cf bundle
localizations in here um
and if you don't have cf bundle
localizations then you'll have to create
it just like in here so as soon as you
see this dict which is dictionary let's
go ahead and create a new key so let's
just say key and we're going to say core
foundation bundle localizations
okay
and then we end the key right there
and what you have to do this the value
of this key is not just a string but
it's actually an array an array meaning
that is a list
of things it's a list of languages or
localizations that your application
supports so
as you see all the other things in here
there they have like these keys and then
values but for us we have to do
something like this you see there's a
key which is cf um
bundle localization and localizations
and we have to then create an array so
let's go up here right after this say
array
and then we close the array just like
that you see this is how they were doing
it here as well
and then we need to add two strings in
here so one string and we close that
string
and another one okay so because we're
supporting english and swedish so every
string in your arraylist is gonna then
um
indicate the language code that your
application supports okay so first we're
gonna support english and then we're
gonna sweet and support swedish and
swedish language code is suv because in
sweden
and sweden itself we don't call the
country sweden we call it sevaria
and that's what that's where sv comes
from but you can also google this and
you can like look for localization
country codes and you will get to a list
on wikipedia or something that tells you
exactly what you have to use for
instance if you want to write um
a special language in india or pakistan
like urdu or whatever you'll have to
find the correct language code for that
so but you can google that easily so um
i'm not gonna present all those
languages code language codes in this
chapter but i'm just giving you the
tools necessary to find out on your own
okay and that is it really that's all we
have to do for the ios app so we've
added the cf bundle localizations in
here and we're good to go for the info p
list
then what we need to do in here is we
need to go into our root folder of our
application and then we need to add a
file as you can see on the bottom of the
screen called l10n and as i told you
this l10n is a
it means a localization that's the 10
thing meaning that there's 10 letters
between l and n in localization so let's
go ahead in here and i'm just going to
right click on this folder in here and
actually here
and then let's add a new file and call
it lpn yamo all right
and
in here then we have to write some stuff
and i'll bring the official
documentation because it is very very
helpful in this case so let's go and
have a look at the documentation what we
have to enter in this ltn file
let's see if we can find it somewhere
and it is an arb file so l10n
and it looks like this so this is this
is like the contents that we kind of
need to place in our l10 file
so as you can see it says
arb directory and it's called lib el
tenen all right and we'll soon have a
look at what this actually means
excuse me
and then we have something called a
template arb file and then something
called an output localization file okay
so um i'm going to explain to you what
this what these all actually mean
so
what
what this arb directory means is it is
an indication for you you're telling um
flutters auto generated localization
engine
where to find your
files where to find your localizations
you see
when you create localizations for a new
language then you have to create a an
arb file so and you're basically telling
dart in this case or flutter in this
case that these arb files i'm going to
create are going to reside under this
folder so if you look at visual studio
code here we have now a folder from all
when we created basically our project
which was called lib as you can see in
here okay
so
in this lib then we're going to create a
folder as it's indicated in here called
l10n well you don't actually have to
call it altenent and that's why you have
this configuration so you could call it
something else you could call it
localization if you want to or my
strings whatever you want to it's just
an indication to flutter and the
localization engine where you're
replacing those files okay
so that's that so that's you're telling
dart where it f it where to find your
localization information then in here
the template arv file is a file in that
directory that you're
basically choosing as the main language
of the application so if for instance it
can't find a key for swedish in the
swedish file arb file it's going to fall
back to the english one and this is like
setting the ground for or setting the
foundation for how you're localizing
your application
you can think of it as the default
language that your application supports
in our case that language is going to be
english so we're going to leave this
file name as it is indicated here
the other thing output localization file
it is a file for that auto generation to
basically create for you so as you'll
soon see auto generation is very special
i mean it's very magic
so um but you have some control over it
and this is like one of those things
that you can control you can actually
control where that auto generated dart
code is going to be generated and in
like what file name
it is a little bit abstract so i'm not
going to go too much into it and you'll
soon see how we can configure this and
what this actually means so what we need
to do in this internationalization
documentation let's just copy this
content
and i'm going to then go in this l10 and
yaml file that we created and just paste
it there okay
what we need to do in here we're going
to leave the arb directory directory as
lib l10 because that kind of makes sense
okay
uh but in here app instead of app ian
i'm just going to say intel yeah it's
just for me it makes more sense to
use
the intl underscore en as the default
file so we're going to create intl en
and then intl
sv for swedish okay and then we're just
going to leave this as it is so i'm just
going to save this file right there and
then what we can do
is just to do a hot restart
now remember hot restarting is something
in internationalization it's very
important flutter because hot reload
won't trigger auto generation of your
internationalization code meaning that
if you have some
if you've added some new strings for
instance to your arb files as we'll talk
about it soon those things won't be auto
injected and generated into your code
until you do a hot restart hot reload
won't cut it so you have to either do a
hot restart or just completely stop the
application and build it from scratch
and that's a huge overhead so you may
not want to do that but a hot restart is
necessary for that okay
so let's have a look now at um
what
arb files are as i mentioned before now
arb files are application resource
bundles and they're pretty much json
files they are key values in there and
your keys are basically how a handle for
your application to then reach into your
localization and grab for instance a
string and the values of those keys are
the actual strings that will be
displayed in your user interface
they are more than just key values
because you can actually put logic in
your arb files in that for instance as
you soon see
inside this screen let me bring it up in
scr cpy and if you log in with a valid
user in here
and we have foobarbas as our
password i think
um in this screen at the moment on the
top of the screen we're seeing your
notes but what we're going to do in this
chapter just to demonstrate how arp
files work we're gonna say if you have
one note
it's just gonna write no
you have one note something like that or
one note
if you have more than one note then it's
gonna say for instance if you have three
notes it's gonna say three notes
or if you have zero notes no notes at
all it's gonna say
you have no notes so
for the same title
which is the title on top of the screen
we can actually put logic into the arb
file to say hey
this isn't a title however i wanted to
say this
if this particular count is zero i
wanted to say you have no notes
if the account is one i want it to say
you have one note or if the count is
more than one i wanted to say you have
x
amount of notes and that x is the actual
number that we will provide to it
so rb files are more than just json they
can actually have logic in them and they
stand as you can see at the bottom of
the screen they stand for application
resource bundle
all right and now what we need to do is
to actually go and create these um files
so let's go into this lib folder
and let's go and create our the folder
that we mentioned in this l10 and you
see we said that under lib we're gonna
have a folder called l10n and under that
l10n we're gonna have a file called intl
en arb okay so let's go ahead and see if
we can get that to work so in lib let's
go and say new file and then i'm going
to say l10n slash
intl en arb
and you can see that it creates the
folder as well lib l10n and intl enarb
and that is the file that we said we're
going to create here
let's then go ahead and say new file
intl and then we're going to say sv arv
okay
and as i mentioned before these are very
simple jsons to begin with so we can
just create a json for instance here and
in the english one first
so like this and in here i'm just going
to say my title
and then a value of my title goes here
okay and let's just copy and paste this
in the swedish one as well just for now
okay
so and i'm just going to do a hot
restart
all right so what this all did since
we've added our auto generation
in our pop speaking ammo if you remember
from before we added this generate true
inside here now what you should be able
to do is to have a look at the structure
of your project and now all of a sudden
you should be able to see a folder
called dot dart tool and if you drill
down in there you should be able to see
something called a flutter gen and if
you drill down in there you'll see gen
l10n and in there you'll see now three
files app localizations app localization
sv and applicalizations en now
what is this app localizations well if
you remember from our um
l10n we actually told the generation to
generate generated code to be named app
localizations and that's
basically it that's that file we said
that it needs to be called that so we
can open that and you'll see now there's
some information in here and
there is a locale name for instance and
then there are some delegate stuff and
i'll explain all these but what you'll
see here now is something called my
title and is a string and this is
exactly what we wrote in this my title
my title goes here
and you can see then if you go to the
english one
your string is there my title goes here
and the swedish one is also saying my
title goes here so it's not so it's not
so impressive since we actually chose to
have the exact same string in the
english and the swedish version so what
we could do is to go to the english one
in this
intel en arb and put eng at the end of
it and go to the swedish one and say
swe like in sweden
okay and then i now get a a save on this
file and then if you go in here you'll
see nothing has changed and that's what
i meant hot
reload doesn't cut it you have to do a
hot restart and if you do a hot restart
then this code should basically get
updated let's go ahead and see if it did
you can see here's the english one oops
i didn't mean to change it and here's
the swedish one so
now you know what those things actually
stand for
and
we now have a really good ground to
stand on because we've created our
localization yaml a configuration file
we have our english and swedish
localization files right here in lib
if you have a look here lib
ltn and under those we have intel en and
intel sv which means intel
internationalization english and
international nationalization swedish
now all we really have to do is to
basically go ahead now and start
populating these um
strings in our application and um kind
of
sorry populating them in the in these
arb files and then where in our
application we have
text hard-coded then we're going to
switch to using these
strings which are in our l10n
file
and in order for our application to
actually understand what
we have localized in inside our arb
files we have to actually tell the
application which locales we support
and in order to
mention sorry in order to explain that
we have to go back to the main dart file
so
let's go to main dart file and have a
look at how we've created our
application and you can see we have this
code right here that at the moment says
run app and then we're creating a
material application
and there are two important properties
in the creation of material app which we
haven't used so far because in the
previous chapters we haven't done any
localization of the application so far
so these two properties are namely
localizations delegate and supported
locales so
let me bring up the caption for this
section um the way flutter localization
communicates with the ios app and
android app or for instance a web
application or desktop whatever you're
running flatter on it needs to tell the
underlying operating system what locales
and it's supporting
so basically that's telling your
material application which languages
your application is built to work with
so that's the locale so you could say
swedish english persian and arabic or
what have you so those are the locales
but you also have the concept of
localization of your widgets
you see at the moment we've created some
strings and and also we're then gonna
soon go and place those strings on our
ui but also flutter itself has
localization support for various
languages there are so many languages
that flutter at the moment supports and
it can internally also localize its own
widgets for instance if you bring up a
date picker for instance in your flutter
application for user to select the date
that day picker itself can have
localization based on the system's
language or your application's language
so if you've chosen arabic career
applications language versus at the os
level
then and if you bring up a date picker
then that date picker is going to be
localized for that language by default
by the flutter team so
you need to tell material app both about
the locales that your application
supports also how it should localize for
instance internal widgets and also your
custom widgets so
what we need to do is to actually go and
add these two properties here
and what we want to do is to refer to
this app localization file so if you go
to dart tools and you can see there's
this app localizations right here
and you can see there is a pop speaking
ammo and and then this is basically a
package so it is a package that was
created for you you haven't done
anything it's just generated for you so
how do we go ahead and import this in
our application and that is by going to
the top of your main file for instance
and say import and then you say package
and then in here we just say flutter
underscore gen
and this is like the generated code for
you and then gen l10n and in there
you'll see that there is
applicabilization's dark files so i need
you to please go ahead and import this
file into your
main dart file
after having done that we need to go to
the material app and right before we do
anything else we're first going to say
supported locales this is a property and
that allows us to tell flutter which
lookouts our application supports
now you may be wondering okay what data
type this is this is actually a list as
you can see it's an iterable of locale
and some people go and incorrectly
create a custom list of accounts and
then put that in here but you don't have
to do that and i actually suggest that
you don't do that even if you can
because if you go inside this
applicalization start file you see that
something down here
it is created for you calls supported
locales
so it is already understanding what
locales your application supports based
on the arb files that you've provided to
um flutter gen so
please don't go and create the same list
in your main dart file in here what
you'll need to do is just to say
applicalizations
and then you just say supported locales
okay so this goes and uses your arb
files as like a guide let's see lib
ltn and ar b fast it just knows that
you're supporting english and swedish at
this point okay
so that's the first thing that we have
to do the other thing that we have to do
in here is just to say
it's called localizations delegates as
you can see it says the delegates for
this apps localizations widget
and this is basically
a way for you to tell flutter that hey i
support for instance swedish and english
please localize your own widgets as well
so in here you don't have to create
custom delegates because those are also
provided inside your applicalizations so
if you go in there you'll see
something in here
localizations delegates all right so
what we need to do now is just to say
applicalizations
localize
app localizations
and then localizations delegates so then
that is provided and i'm going to do a
hot restart just because we've changed
the main function in our application and
those changes aren't going to take
effect until you do a hot restart okay
and what we can do now is to go ahead
and test these changes
and um
what would be really great is actually
if you could extract that little title
that we've written in our intel en arb
and and put it somewhere on some sort of
widget just to see that it is working in
english and in swedish so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to bring scr cpy on
the screen
right here at the moment you can see
we're on the login page so let's go to
the login page and you don't have to do
this so i'm just going to do this myself
just to demonstrate something and while
we're in the login page let's also clean
up these two unused imports okay and
let's go ahead into our code here to the
login and you can see there's a cons
text login but in here we want to use
that title and again you don't have to
do this and i actually suggest you don't
do it it's just for me demonstrating to
you that hey it's working as expected
okay so just follow along and look at
this part without having to do it
yourself so what we need to do in here
let's go and import the same
localization so i'm just going to say
import
package
and then we had flutter lock
what was it called let's go to main dart
file and and exactly copy and paste that
flutter gen okay and i'm gonna bring it
into login view dot dart
i'm gonna paste it there so we also have
access to our localizations and the way
to grab your localizations is with this
code so if i write this for instance
just in here i'm going to remove
actually let cons be there i just want
you to see why we have to remove const
in the future so for us to be able to
grab this string which is my title in
our login view we have to say app
localizations
of
context and then we can say my title and
then we have to explicitly on wrapless
okay so this is how you grab a
localization out of your um supported
localizations basically the stuff that
you placed in your
arv files okay
so now we have my title and in here as
you can see
it says hey a value of type null can't
be assigned so
basically this is an issue with having
constant here because in in the previous
i mean up until this point the way we've
created our app bar was that we said
that is a constant string it's a
constant text that says login but now
that all of a sudden we're saying we're
retrieving this text from our
applicalizations these properties
unfortunately are not
defined as
constants so if you go in here you can
see it's just a string getter and that's
the reason you can't have cons in here
so i'm just going to remove that cons
it's going to be very happy and the
reason we have this exclamation mark in
here is that the app localization is off
function and you can see it returns an
optional application it is a bit
unfortunate i don't really like the
syntax that everywhere we have to go on
applications of context and
a
um
an exclamation mark in here and we're
actually going to fix that soon right
after this demonstration and because
this is
as you'll see soon it is soon gonna get
quite annoying to have to always say
applicalizations of context exclamation
mark dot and then the name of your
property but so hang on we'll fix that
soon so now we have the login in here
and i'm going to do a hot restart
and let's see what we get i'm going to
bring scrcpy and now you can see i see
my title goes here swedish all right
and that's the title that we put in the
intel
um
swedish you see right here okay
so we have that english one let me bring
the swedish one next to the english one
as well like that
so we have the english one and the
swedish one here and you can see at the
moment we're seeing the swedish one and
the way to actually change the language
of your um phone on android is a little
bit different from ios so here i'm just
going to go to
install nina and that's settings and in
here i believe it is somewhere
it's in system i believe
and then spirowak which means language
and then i'm going to go to language and
at the moment spirowak here is swedish
i'm just going to bring english on top
and you can see now english is on top so
let's go back to our application and see
if its title is going to change and now
all of a sudden you see that it's
displaying the english title so it's
working very very well on android i'm
gonna get rid of the scr cpy on the
screen and bring up
a an ios
device which i've created with um
so it's an iphone 12 pro that is sitting
on my desk right here and i have
quicktime which is mirroring that iphone
screen here so let's go ahead and in
here stop the process on android and
then command shift b on macintosh to
select the device or control should be
on windows and linux and say select
device and then i'm going to choose that
iphone 12 pro and i'm going to go to the
main dart file because that's how we
should run the application because if
you try to run the application when
you're on this file it's just going to
give you an error telling you hey i
don't know how to run an arb file so
that's the reason you always have to go
to a dart file
in your application so that visual
studio code at least knows how to run
your application
so
now let's bring up um
our um
quicktime here and let's wait basically
for this running xcode build process to
finish
and as i've mentioned before sometimes
xcode can actually be
much slower than building with gradle so
that is quite annoying um so i'm just
gonna wait here until this process is
done let's see how long it takes
oh it's installing that so i don't
actually have to do anything so
installing and launching it says at the
moment
so let's get ready
let's see how long that takes and i can
see now that it's going to install the
application right here we should see
some sort of progress
on my notes
right there okay
now it is launching the application and
we can see that at the moment the user
and face is english and um so i'm gonna
close this widget
and then bring visual studio code here
as well all right fantastic so um
unfortunately mirroring
an iphone a real iphone on your computer
screen with quicktime isn't going to
allow you to interact with that iphone
at all and scr cpy is very special in
that it connects with adb and at the low
level it allows you to interact with the
screen
however the same thing isn't true when
you're mirroring an iphone screen so
right now i have to go and interact with
this phone by hand so
i'm going to grab this phone
and it is right here i don't know if the
cable is long enough for me to show you
so here is the phone right there
and i'm going to then go to system
settings right here
and i'm then going to go to general
and um
and then let's go to language and region
and in there i'm going to choose swedish
right here and
the the thing that is a bit
disappointing in ios is that the
language that you choose for your system
is for the entire system and when you do
that it's going to kill all the running
applications because ios applications
don't have the possibility to change
their language on the fly that's
something
like android does very very well in that
you can change the language of the
entire system and nothing has to restart
the applications keep running you could
even see when we changed the language
the um like here we couldn't we didn't
basically see the application
terminate or anything so
what we need to do now is to ensure that
we don't change the entire system's
language instead i'm going to show you a
way that you can choose to do in ios
that changes only your applications
language so let's go back in here and
let's go and find our application which
is called my notes i believe somewhere
and let's see if you can find it and
it's right there my notes and now you
can see that there's a menu at the
bottom of the screen that says language
and then i'm going to tap on that and
then i'm going to choose swedish and the
reason that you're seeing these two
options in here because the change we
made in our info p list so if i say main
sorry info p list
we can see that we said english and
swedish in this order and that's why
they are displayed here also in that
order so i'm going to then choose
swedish and as soon as i do this you'll
see up here that our application will
terminate because ios can't handle that
so
and there we go the application's
completely terminated now
but that's okay so i'm gonna go back
here and then open the application on
ios oh now we have to debug it as well
okay because we're in debug mode so
let's go ahead and main dark file and
then run the application again
and you can see it says in ios 14 plus
debug mode flatter apps can only be
launched from flutter tooling ids with
flutter plugins or from xcode
so this is a little bit unfortunate as
well um
because then you have to basically run
your
build
over and over again just while you're
testing and this is another
i would say it's one of the shortcomings
of running applications on ios as well
like there are so many things i feel
like android is ahead of ios
that it's just android is a little bit
more developer friendly i would say
the tooling
the whole operating system is a little
bit more friendly so let's see
um i can see now at the bottom of the
screen it says installing and launching
so let's have a look here now our user
interface should be in swedish
if everything goes well of course
and
if things are going well then on ios we
don't have to do this process over and
over again so it's just just to make
sure that it's working for the first
time as you can see now after changing
our applications into language to
swedish now we can see the swedish title
being displayed on top all right
so i'm going to close the widget
inspector right there
and i'm going to stop this process and
i'm going to get rid of this and now we
should be focusing only then on
deploying on android because it's just
so much easier
so let's go and do a flaster select and
then i'm going to say i'm choosing to
run my application on my android device
then i'm gonna put away my iphone
great
so that is that and and the thing that
we need to talk about now is at the
optionality of this app localizations so
if you go back to our login view you saw
that
applicalizations of context is an
optional value because this function
returns an optional app localizations
and there is a way to make this better
it's one of my favorite ways it's like
the shortest extension that we can write
in our flutter career progress
but it's one of the most powerful as
you'll soon see
in order not to have to repeat this code
what we could do is to create an
extension on build context that grabs
its applicalizations and returns it as a
non-optional value so here we have
applicalizations being returned by
passing the context in but what we are
going to do is to grab the applications
from the context itself all right
so let's have a look at um
how we can actually do that in order in
order to get started let's leave this
code as it is right there we don't have
to do anything special but what we're
going to do is to go as you can see at
the bottom of the screen we have to go
and create a new file under lib
extensions and then we're going to
create a new folder as well called build
context lock dot dart and lock as in
localization in this file we're going to
create our extension on build contacts
that allows us to
return our localizations to the caller
all right
so let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to go to lib in here and then
we have um as the bottom at the bottom
of the screen says extensions we already
have the extensions folder but we only
have list folder in there with a filter
file so in extensions i'm just going to
right click and say new file then let's
go ahead and create build context slash
lock dart okay
and in here what we're going to do is to
say
um import
our flutter
sorry package
after gen as we did in the other places
and then gen l10n applicalization starts
okay
so that's the first import and in here
we don't we only need a few symbols or
actually one symbol which is the
applicalizations but we'll talk about
that soon so let's go ahead and say
extension um and we're gonna say
localization on build context as you'll
see it says i have to also import this
because it is in material so i'm gonna
say go ahead and import it
and i really don't like as if as you
follow along with this course i don't
like to import everything in material
like if i only need build context i only
need build context so i'm not going to
import everything so let's just go ahead
and say show build context
and that only brings build context in
this
context
so
what we need to do in here we're going
to create basically a getter which
returns app localizations
applocalizations we're going to say this
is a getter and it's called lock
and what it does is is returns
applicalizations
of
this
and it puts a
an exclamation mark at the end of it so
and also you'll see that we've imported
applications as a whole but we only need
app localizations from that file so i'm
just gonna say show this okay
so that's that file now it's created and
and while this all is going on i'm gonna
select that and also i'm gonna say run
because it is always good to have the
application running as we're doing hot
restarts and hot reload so we can see
the results on the screen so with this
extension now you're soon gonna be able
to say build context
dot
and then you can get your localizations
so let's go back now to this login view
what we wrote here as you can see is
this syntax at the moment but what you
can replace the syntax with is if we
remove this and we just say context
which is our build context and then you
say dot lock and you'll see here it says
oh i don't know what lock is and that's
correct it doesn't know what lock is
because we haven't imported that
extension
sorry about that i'll just close the
switches inspector
so it doesn't know what that is so i'm
just going to say command dot and it's
going to auto import it for me great and
now we can just say my title
i mean tell me this isn't better this is
for me 100 times better like if you
compare this with what we had before
which was this i mean come on
it's a lot shorter a lot more is the
same and i personally think it is it is
a better code so
let me go back all right so let's leave
this here for now okay just my title
let's leave it there and let's go to our
android application which is scrcpy in
here and we can see that it's displaying
the correct title so if i do a hot
restart as well it's still going to work
and display the string from our
um
from our arb file
now that we've done this
we actually have to talk about
all right how are we going to go about
localizing things
well this is the important part you see
localizing is in a lot of places quite a
boring work in that you have to
literally go for instance if if you're i
mean it is boring if you're doing it the
way we are doing it in this chapter and
that you have to go and collect all
these strings
excuse me and then you have to go and
place them in your arb files and then
you have to also place them in the
swedish arab file and then you have to
do the translation
etc so you have to create keys for all
of these so
this is quite a boring work and it is
not something that we're gonna do in
this chapter because i've already
prepared all those for you so you don't
have to go and write them by your by
yourself so
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to literally go and bring all those
strings that i've prepared for you
and let me see if i can find them
somewhere
in the en rb
okay i found them right here
and what i'm going to do then is i'm
going to just bring all those strings
and place them
in our intel en
arabi file so here you see at the moment
we have my title and i'm just going to
leave my title in there because we're
using it right now but we're going to
have to delete it soon
and i'm going to paste all these strings
that i've prepared for us okay so there
we go all of those are here now and
there is a github repository for this uh
for this
uh course of course and you can go after
this
chapter is done you can go to that
github repository and retrieve all these
strings so you don't have to type them
by hand either so
it is nothing n nothing at all special
going on about this as you can see we
have just a logout button that says log
out we have versus a cancel button we
have the verify email which is something
that we're using in the verify email
screen for instance we have the register
button we have the restart button let's
see where the restart is used
it is i believe
oh restart i believe it is inside the
verify email screen so if i created for
instance um
if i say pixel to a b gmail foo bar
about and i say
um oh sorry to register screen so let's
say pixelity
gmail.com foo barbaz i'm gonna register
this user and then we're gonna go into
this screen at the moment it says
restart and that's this key restart okay
so i literally gone to through all our
screens all our dialogues as well and
collected all those strings and placed
them here in this
international internationalization enarb
file and i've also done the same thing
for swedish so i'm going to go and bring
those files i'm sorry bring those keys
in here so i've done the translation to
swedish and i'm not my mother tongue
isn't swedish so but i've lived in
sweden for a long time so um i can't
speak swedish a little bit
actually enough i can speak enough and
i'm gonna paste those string in strings
in here as you can see they're
completely in swedish okay so what i've
done is literally we have the english
ones you can see here and we have the
swedish ones so it's the same keys but
different values
and again don't worry i understand if
you're watching this course you're like
oh but how am i going to get all these
just please go to the github repository
and you can extract these values you
don't have to type them by hand
and
you should be good to go
so now we have these in order for our
localizations to be generated in these
dark tool files let's go to
flutter jan and have a look at this gen
10 l
gen l10n you can see those strings
aren't here at the moment because only
my title should be here somewhere let's
see if you can find it
let's see en
locale should reload my title you see
nothing else is in here but if we
do a hot restart all those strings
should get generated and then we should
have them all here you can see login
verify email all these are provided
right here okay
so
that's that part so now we have all our
strings and we should just be able to do
the coding part which is the fun part so
let's go ahead and take care of that i'm
going to close all these files that are
there at the moment so we have a clean
slate to work with
the first thing that we're going to do
is to localize our um what is it called
cannot share empty note dialogue so
let's go ahead in there and then i'm
going to say command shift p and go to
cannot share empty now dialog
if you remember if you're if the user is
trying to share a dial sharing note that
is its contents is empty
so sharing in this case we have a key
for it so we're just going to say
context.lock
and remember
this lock is an extension that we've
created we don't have access to it
unless we import it so i'm just going to
say command dot in visual studio code
and it's going to also import that file
for me
just right here as you can see
and now we have access to all our
strings okay so in here we're just going
to say sharing
which is a key i've created remember all
these keys are in the arb file
and you cannot share an empty note so
we're going to say context.log
cannot share empty node prompt
which is a key again i've called an okay
we also have
okay
right
so and now we've localized our show
cannot share empty notes dialog
fantastic
so let's go ahead and
localize our delete dialogue so i'm
going to say command shift p visual
studio code on mac or control should be
usually code for windows and linux and
this and let's say delete dialog
in here we have this um
little uh title in here so let's just
say um context dot lock and remember
we're in a new file we don't have access
to log let's auto import it
and in here i'm just gonna say delete
that
and prompt we're going to say context
unlock and delete nodes prompt
cancel context dot log cancel
and here context.lock and was it okay or
it's yes so let's just say yes all right
so that's the localization of this file
as well i'm going to say command command
s or just hot restart the whole thing
maybe it's better and i can see a crcy
crashed unfortunately and that's the
problem i've had with this cr cpy for a
long time that's okay it's an open
source software i'm just gonna say
select device
and this and i'm gonna run the
application so we have it running in the
background
fantastic
so uh that's the delete dialog now i
have to capture at the bottom of the
screen in case we have to go and
localize pretty much everything in our
application up to this point and now the
next step is to localize the error
dialog so let's say error dialog
and in here let's just you can see it
says an error occurred and we've called
a generic error prompt in our arb file
if you look here
generic error progresses and error
occurred okay
so let's go ahead and use that here so
i'm just going to say context.lock
auto import i don't have to explain that
anymore and then we say generic error
prompt
we have an ok as well so context lock
okay
so that's done as well
then we have to go and localize our log
out dialog so let's go to log out dialog
and here log out
dialog
and we're going to do the same thing in
here so let's just go ahead and say that
we're going to use the log out button in
here and you see we have log out in a
few places like if you remember in the
main application interface when you're
logged in with an actual user i'm going
to bring in crcpy so you know what i'm
talking about
if you look at this screen if i say
restart and if i log in with a user and
i say van.mp gmail.com
fubar
as
when you log in with an actual user then
you have this little log out in here and
it says log out and at the same time
when you tap on it then there's this
dialog that says logout so we have a
choice in here either you go and define
two log out strings with different keys
in your arb file or you just define one
and that's exactly what i've done so
we're in here i'm just going to say
context.lock that's how to import
and in here we're just going to say log
out button okay
and it says log out button i understand
it's the title of a dialogue and we're
calling the log out button you may just
go ahead and call this key log out if
you want to i'll just call the log that
logout button remember these are just
keys you can change them easily okay
now that's that's for our title and then
for the content we're going to say
context log
log out and dialog prompt and we have a
cancel button here so let's say let's
just say context log cancel
and again we have another log out button
you can see here so log out here log out
here and then log out in here so there
are three places using the same thing or
same string context
log and then we're going to say log out
button all right
so that's great so that's that part as
well i'm just gonna do command s to hot
reload
the next thing that we have to do at the
bottom of the screen in the case in the
caption we have to go and localize our
password reset dialogue so i'm going to
remove log out dialog here and close the
tab and let's go to password reset
email sends dialog
and in here we have this password reset
and i'm going to go to my notes as well
so let's go in here for the title and
say context
block auto import
and we're going to call it password
reset it's one of the keys i define and
in here we're going to say context lock
password reset dialog prompt okay
and we have an ok button so you now by
this point that we have an ok key as
well in our
in our arb file
so now we've done basically we're done
uh localizing the show password recent
dialogue uh uh show password reset sends
dialogue
okay the next uh dialog is um
forgot password so let's go to
that screen
that sorry this is not a dialogue this
is actually a view so we're going to go
to forgot password view
here i mean when it comes to views our
job is a little bit more difficult
because up until this point we've pretty
much everywhere
used constants like if you look at this
is a constant string here's a constant
text
here is constant so everywhere that
we're going to localize our strings and
we were using const before we have to
remove that cons now because our
localized properties inside arv funds
are unfortunately not defined as const
and i don't really know the reasoning
behind that simply maybe because there
are
getters and maybe getters can't be
constant or there are some
other problems with the generation maybe
that um the flutter team decided that
well these can't be constants but that's
something that's the truth that we have
to live with at the moment so
let's go ahead and find all our strings
and we're going to start localizing them
one at a time before i got password view
so here in this show error dialog and
i've called this key forgot password
view generic error so let's remove this
string and just say
context lock
let's auto import log
and we say forgot password
view generic error and i'm going to put
a comma at the end so it's formatted
nicely so let's go to this forgot
password title itself so i'm gonna
remove the const remember i just
explained that so we're gonna say
context log and we're gonna say forgot
password that's the key i've defined
and you can also see its description
here and you can see it says forgot
password okay
in english this message translates to
forgot password okay
so this thing i've called it forgot
password view prompt so let's remove the
const remove the string itself and we're
going to say
context log forgot password prompt
forgot password view prompt and put a
comma at the end and let's have a look
at the documentation for this as you can
see it says if you forgot your password
simply enter your email and we'll send
you a password recent link okay
so that's one thing and then in your
email address um
it says input decoration your email
address because that's a forgot password
screen let's go here and have a look at
it see how it looks like
here i forgot my password so here's that
little input decoration
so
i can see i've called it email text
field placeholder so let's remove this
const and in here we're going to say
context log email placeholder text field
okay
let's go ahead and have a look at this
one so let's remove the const it says
send me password recent link and i can
see that i've called that
forgot password view send me link so
context log for god password forgot
send me link here and put a comma at the
end so the dart formatter
gets busy with formatting the code and
in here back to login view
i can see that i've called it forgot
password view back to login so
context
here
context lock forgot
back okay so and this is this is a
technique that you can also use like if
you want to get like a property like
this that's quite long name and you want
to get the name immediately right you
could just write a few keywords of that
name for instance i know that for god
and back are quite unique names so if i
say forgot back it it's gonna show me
that so
it has this like partial search kind of
in its intelligence which is very very
useful
the next thing that we have to do is to
go ahead and localize our login view so
i'm going to close the screen forgot
password view and go to login view
login view right here and we're going to
start at the bottom at the top of the
screen and
we'll remove this unused import right
there in login view
and let's go ahead and start by uh
localizing our dialogs so the first one
is cannot find a user with the entered
credentials and i've called it cannot
find user
or login view cannot find user so i'm
just going to say context.log let's auto
import log
or it was already imported okay that's
great and let's just say it is called
login error cannot find user cannot find
user okay
the next one i'm going to put some
commas in here get dark formatter to do
its job correctly and i'm going to press
command s to save the file and that's
going to format the file for me for
wrong credentials i've called it login
error wrong credentials so context log
and wrong credentials
next one is authentication error and we
just call it login error author so
context lock author okay so that's that
one as well now at the top of the login
login view we have this little text that
says please log in your account in order
to interact with and create notes
and this one i can see
i've just called
a login view prompt but i wonder what
happened to our title as you can see we
have this my title now that we're in the
login view it is a good time to actually
go and get rid of that okay so i'm going
to open um
intel
e and arb
and i'm going to kill this basically my
title and i suggest that you also go to
the swedish file which is intel sv and
kill this title as well okay so we've
removed that and i'm gonna get rid of
that then i'm gonna
hot restart so that the code generation
kicks in and as you can see in here my
title isn't valid anymore and in this i
mean this title is called now login if
you can look at the documentation in
here you can see in english it just says
login fantastic
so let's remove this constant here from
the prompt as well and we're just going
to say context lock and let's just say
login prompt so i'm going to do a prompt
okay
so for the enter email um
text field placeholder here enter your
email here we're gonna remove the const
and let's just say context lock
and we're gonna say email placeholder
okay
and we also have an enter your password
here placeholder so let's remove the
cons in here i'm just gonna say context
lock
password
placeholder okay password field password
text field placeholder that's the full
name
and we have this uh login in here so
what we need to do is just to change
this text as well so let's remove the
content here i'm just gonna say context
dot walk
login
and i forgot my password so i'm going to
say context lock and i believe it's
called forgot password
login view forgot password okay
it's not a constant anymore and put a
comma here it's just good practice to
put comma at the end of your parameters
even if it's just one argument that
you're passing to a function i mean my
reason this is a little bit of a side
though but my reasoning is that any time
in the future anybody anybody wants to
add new parameters to this text widget
then they will have to go and put that
comma in there but if you as a
programmer who wrote this code in the
beginning you put the comma in there
you're kind of like acknowledging the
fact that hey i appreciate your time you
may be wanting to add now you may be
wanting to add new parameters to this
and i've already prepared this for you
so if you don't do this if i want to as
a programmer add new parameters in here
i have to go and say oh well okay comma
commandments go here blah blah
but if you'd added that already i'll
just say enter and then write my
parameters
okay great so what we can do now is to
scroll forward here and localize the
rest of these properties and it can't i
can just see here that we have one
property left here which at the moment
says not registered yet registered here
so let's go ahead and remove the const
as we usually do then and say contacts
lock
and i can see it's called not registered
so let's use that and a comma here so we
prepared for the next programmer so to
say
and we could just say now that we have
successfully localized our login view at
the moment so we could just close this
tab
the next step is to localize our
register view so the register view also
has quite a few things that we have to
localize so let's go ahead and go to
register view
and while we're here i mean this is what
i'm again i
when i started this course i wanted you
to become a software engineer even if
you were like
a designer a ux or whatever or project
manager and you have to put yourself and
your yourself in the shoes of a software
developer software developer you're
always in like time constraint usually
our time concern to deliver but at the
same time
when you stumble upon something that is
quickly fixed please do it on
right there uh at that point because if
you leave these things they're gonna
pile up
and many small things that could be
corrected on the fly if you just leave
them they're gonna become a big pile and
then you're not gonna be able to have
enough time to fix them all so while
we're here we have two unused imports
let's just remove them because that's
just good practice not to have unused
imports
now let's go to our register view here
we can see there's quite a lot of errors
there are four errors so the first thing
i'm gonna do is to put commas at the end
of these
right there and i'm going to press
command s on macintosh or control s on
windows linux and that's going to do the
formatting
the first one is called weak password so
let's just say context
lock and also import this
and this message is register error weak
password so weak password
like that
the next one is called context log and
it's called an email already in use okay
fail to register i've called register
error
generic
so context lock
here it's register error generic and
this invalid email is called context
lock and register invalid email okay
so those are our errors we didn't have
to change anything with constant because
these messages weren't constant when
they were passed into this
constructor
then we have to fix this register's
title and it's just called a register so
i'm going to remove the con const
i'm going to say context log register
here
and then we have enter your email and
password to see your notes and i've
called that the register view prompt
so context lock register view prompt
we have this input declaration again
we've done this before with the email
and password so it's nothing surprising
so let's just say context
block email placeholder and this one is
a password placeholder so let's remove
the const
a context lock password
placeholder all right so that's that
then we have the register button that we
also have to
localize and let's remove the constant
here and just say context
lock register
and already registered is called already
registered so let's remove the constant
const as well
and we say context lock already
registered
all right and a comma at the end as well
and we could do the same thing in here
with a comma at the end just to do the
formatting right okay
so this seems to be ready we've now
localized the register view
and the next step is to localize the
verify email view so i'm going to close
this file and let's go ahead to verify
email view
and again we have two unused imports
let's remove those and let's go ahead to
verify email in here and we've just
called it verify email so i'm removing
removing const saying context of lock
and
let's say verify email okay and this is
one thing that i've also fixed and you
could see that in how we've developed
the application so far we have two
texts on top of the verify email view
and they kind of look like this if i
bring it up
let's go to
try to log in with a user who hasn't
verified
his email
and you can see we end up here we've
sent you an email verification please
open it to verify your account
and this is like there are two text
fields but what i've done is i've made
it one text prompt so let's just remove
the second text field and the way i've
created this it's um if we go to our
intel en rb and if you look at the
verify
prompt you can see i've written we've
sent you an email verification please
open on your
open it to verify your account and then
the rest of the string it just follows
along so it's just one paragraph
and so that's why we're removing the
second text in here
so and we're gonna remove this const i'm
gonna remove the text
and
then we're going to say context lock
verify prompt
okay and a comma
we have this a little text button in
here that says send email verification
and this looks like this
let's change that as well and here we're
gonna say context
lock
and it is called verify
send email verification put a comma here
okay
and for the restart button we have a
restart text so we're just going to say
context log restart
and a comma at the end all right
so that's the localization of this
screen as well so we could say we're
pretty much done with the verify email
localization as well
and while we're here to be honest with
you we could also clean up a little bit
here in this verify email while we're
basically cleaning up the view itself
you can see that this text doesn't have
any padding what we could do is to in
this whole column actually
maybe pad this text so we're going to
say this text is padded wrap it with a
padding okay and we could just say
padding of 16. so
you can see now it is a little bit
cleaner it's just a very little uh
effort to make the the ui look a lot
cleaner okay
so we're done with that screen and what
we need to do um we need to actually
localize the create update node view so
let's go ahead to create update note
view
another unused import let's remove that
and let's have a look at what exactly we
have to
localize in here it's probably the the
views title so if we scroll down to
where we're displaying the new note so
if i log in with the user who has
verified his email address
this user
our baz
horrible password please don't use that
password at the moment you can see in
here
we're basically saying um sorry
new note here
we're saying new note and that's this
thing so let's just change that and say
context
dot lock auto import disk oops how to
import this and then we're just going to
say note
okay
and you can see in the documentation it
says it just in the english one says
note so here we're not saying new notes
and the reason behind that is that up
until this point our application is
being say new notes but what happens if
you tap on an existing note
it still says new note so that's the
reason i've decided to basically change
this text just to say note
and put a comma in here to prepare for
the next person as well
and what we're going to do and is also
to change this text decoration and which
is here it says start typing your note
okay so remove the const
and then in here we call it start typing
your note so context log start typing
your note
all right great
so we're going to save that as well
and we're done with that so
now we're going to go to localizing our
notes view and this is i would say this
is like the most exciting localization
part because
we need to do some more coding it's not
as easy so
for just two just to because remember in
the beginning of this chapter i
mentioned that arb files are more than
just normal json in that they can have
logic in them and at the moment if we go
back to our
let's see if i bring scr cpy here at the
moment you can see it just says your
notes
and i wanted to kind of demonstrate how
arb files can be quite dynamic and can
have logic in them and i thought okay
how do i demonstrate that to you and
what i decided to do is
um
that
if you
land in this page and you have no notes
like in this case at the moment it says
your notes but what we're gonna do is to
say okay we have some some key in our
localization file that is called your
notes okay or sorry it's called notes
title
is a key but this key is going to have
some value that has actual logic in it
and this logic has to do with the plural
pluralization of this key if you have no
notes
in english we're going to say no notes
yet
if you have one note it's just gonna say
one note
and if you have
other number of notes such as two three
four then it's going to say
x
notes for instance x being three notes
four notes so it's just gonna say four
notes
so no notes yet one note or x notes
so it has pluralization built into it
and how we have to do that is to use
something in arb called placeholders and
i'll show you how to do that right now
so let's go ahead first into our
intel en
and at the bottom of the screen here
what we're going to do is to first
create our key so that's the most
important one okay so we're going to
call it notes title
and in here we know that we're going to
have some value and let's see we have
also a semi sorry a colon there okay
so we have notes title how do we put our
logic in here
we just know that
we need to have some sort of a
account you see
your localization arb file doesn't know
anything about the count because it's
the application that knows how many
nodes are available in the in the fire
store database so
somehow we need to pass this count to
our application
sorry to our arb file and you do that
with parameterization so you go ahead
and create curly brackets in here and
you would say okay hey i want to have a
parameter called count this count needs
to be passed to this
um
notes title in order for it to be able
to calculate exactly what it has to
return so it's just you
saying that hey application if you want
to get the notes title localized string
you have to pass a parameter to me call
count okay
now what we're going to do is to go and
call and basically and create discount
as a parameter so what you have to do is
to go to the next line and just say adds
notes title this is how you tell arb
that hey
this notes title key has some extra
logic in it okay
then there is a key in here called
placeholders
so you have to write placeholders okay
and in here basically you say
placeholders and then every key is the
name of the parameter itself so account
all right and then you basically start
that and then what you have to do is you
have to define two keys in here one is a
type
and the oops
type and then the other one is an
example
like this so let's have a look at how
this actually looks like
so
basically what we're telling and
arb is that or dart in this case we're
saying that hey this notes title key in
our arab has a parameter called count
and in in here we're saying hey
these are the placeholders the name it's
count and it's type now you have to
define a type you have to actually tell
dart that hey
what data type is this using is it a
string is it's an integer is it a
boolean what is it so in here you just
say it's an integer and then as you'll
see soon the code generation then has a
look at this and says okay i expect you
to send an integer and it's going to
create a function called node's title
with account a parameter of type integer
so this is very important it's the data
type of that count parameter okay
and an example is just for you to know
okay how is this going to be used so an
example is for instance three nodes okay
so we're just going to say here's an
example of how the result of this thing
can look like
right
so what we need to do now is to tell
this um erb and dart code generator here
that this count actually has a logic
about it being plural so it has
pluralization logic and the way to do
that is you put a comma here and you say
plural and a comma after that because
then you have to specify the logic for
that pluralization so
and look
as a side note i completely understand
that this is so weird i mean it is a
strange syntax i don't feel comfortable
with it i sometimes use i sometimes look
at the documentation just to be a
reminder of this
logic but the way i look at it is that
it's the best thing we have let's not
hate on it let's just use it let's
understand that it has power there are
reasons for it being the way it is and
even though we are not 100
like
in
in we weren't involved in the reasoning
of this we don't even know what the
reasoning is but this is what the format
is and this is what we have to basically
go with
so the way to create this is for you to
uh
have your logic in here so we're going
to say equal to zero
and let's just do it like this and then
we're gonna say equal to one and then
we're gonna say other
okay
so this is how you create it so you're
saying that if the value of this count
is zero
then we are going to do something here
if the value of that count is one we're
gonna do something here and if it's
anything else denoted by other we're
gonna do something in here so let's say
when it's equal to zero we're gonna say
no
notes yet okay so that's the string
we're gonna display if the count is zero
if it's equal to one we're just going to
say one note
and then the important thing is if we
end up in this situation if it's other
then we want to say in this case we
actually want to get the count so if you
pass the value of three we want to say
three notes so the way to get that count
is with another curly bracket pair and
you say count and then you say notes
okay
so that's how you create these things so
um and i think we're actually missing a
curly bracket and that is
the the curly bracket at the end yes
this curly bracket which belongs to like
if we
if you look here
if i remove these
the other has two curly brackets
and
it's two curly brackets and here
other one curly bracket there one curly
bracket here one ends here and one ends
here so this last curly bracket here is
for the curly bracket that started here
so again i i don't know what to say this
is the format the way it is we just have
to live with it okay so we've created
the notes title and what we're going to
do is to go ahead and do the same thing
but for swedish and i've already
prepared that so i'm just going to go
ahead and grab that string from the
swedish one that i've
already made so we don't have to type
all that again
so let me go and grab that and bring it
into
l10n
sv which is for swedish and then bring
it at the bottom of the screen
and paste it right there and with a
comma at the end of that line so you can
see plural and it says no notes yet
for one it says one note and for other
it just says
x
notes all right
so i'm gonna save this i'm gonna save
this and i'm gonna do a hot restart
let's just hope that scr cpy doesn't
crash and it didn't
so what we're gonna do now is i was as
it was planned we're gonna go to our
notes view
and i'm gonna go to my notes as well
here let's go to notes view
and have a look at our title in here
and you see we at the moment we're
seeing your notes but what we really
want is to be able to display the number
of notes that are
inside our um
inside the nodes provider so if we have
a look at how we're reading the num and
the notes you can see we're using the
note service and then we're saying all
nodes and this is a stream
of an i triple of cloud nodes so we kind
of wanted stream builder we want a
stream builder to create our title our
app bar and we're going to exactly do
the same thing so we're going to have a
stream builder that creates our app bar
okay
but
or actually it's going to create the
text but how do we get the count of
the notes and the way to do that is with
a little handy extension that i'm going
to show you how to create so
let's go in here in our notes view and
we're going to say extension and we're
going to say count
and we want to create it on a stream so
we're going to say any stream has to be
able to like any stream that has an
iterable in it
that its values are iterable
we want to create a
property called length for instance that
it gets the length so
let's go in here and say okay this
stream has some value but we want that
value to be
iterable
okay so here we're basically saying that
we're extending any stream that contains
uh i troubles as its value is gonna have
this extension
then we're gonna say okay the value of
this is gonna be an hint
and we're going to call it get links
okay
and what this is basically going to do
is to
say it maps the stream's values so let's
say event
and in here we just say it returns the
event's length so i understand this may
be a little bit cryptic for you to
understand but um
you have to know that every stream
is a generic function like if you sorry
it's a generic class you can see it's
abstract class it's it has a parameter
called t which is it's generic type so
what we're saying here we're saying that
okay we're creating an extension on any
stream whose parameters or whose types
are and i treble and iterable has a
length
and that means that we can then extend
and extend any stream that has an i
treble and then we return its property
called get length okay
so what we need to do now is to go ahead
and inside the app bar in here
we have a const text when we need to
remove this const first actually let's
keep it and i'm gonna
see if we can wrap this with a stream
builder now okay so in here what we're
gonna do is we're saying here's a stream
builder and we don't yet know what it is
it's stream is
note service
like this and we have all notes
and the owner user id is our user id
okay as exactly as we have it here
okay but here the stream we don't
actually want the notes we want the
length of notes so let's just say get
length
where is it here get length okay
and now we know that snapshot can then
return that uh value for us so
if i press command s in here let's put a
comma here as well
you can see nothing has changed it just
says your notes because we're still
seeing your notes in here okay but what
we want is to grab the data out of our
snapshot and this snapshot is an async
snapshot
of an integer
let's see undefined class it's called
async snapshots yeah just like that all
right
so you either could tell a stream
builder of int
and then your snapshot i believe
automatically will be
as facing snatch out of it or you could
just say stream builder normal stream
builder and an async snapshot of it so
you could type it in two different ways
and i've just chosen to do it this way
all right
what we need to do in here is to see as
soon as snapshot has data then we grab
that data which means it has the length
built into it okay
so we're going to say if snapshot has
data which means it has length
otherwise we're just going to return
const of text nothing meaning that well
well we don't have anything to display
at the top of the screen if this
snapshot has no text all right
and then in here we're going to say it's
going to say final note count
is snapchat date
okay
or zero because it just says yeah i may
not have data
just strange because you're actually
saying has data but these two properties
are kind of like
they're different from you i mean
they're not different but they're
separated from each other just because
you're checking something has data
doesn't mean necessarily that the next
line should understand that it has data
the data type
of this data property is still final t
so you can't change that okay and that's
why we have this um elvis sign kind of
here
or a question mark question mark just to
say if this doesn't have any value just
use zero okay
now that we have node count we have to
get that context
block
and we oh we don't have log let's import
that
and remember the key that we used intel
me and it's called notes title let's say
notes title and now all of a sudden you
can see it is a function that takes in
an integer hello that's the count
integer that we built into our arb and
it returns a string you can see here
that's perfect because then we can pass
the note count in here
okay
and this will be our text
and then we could just say
return
a text widget with that text in it just
like this
all right
and then we can save this and as you can
see now as soon as i hit command s it
says no notes yet
if i say and if i press the plus button
here you can see i can type something in
here and i go back it says onenote
if i create another one
on top of the screen it says two notes
and that's it pretty much that's the
logic that we built into it so now it
says onenote delete that note and it
says no notes yet perfect so that logic
seems to be working fine for us
so that's that part and we also have
another string at the bottom of this
screen which says log out
and we have to change this as well so
we have to say context
log out button
and this error is because we it says
invalid constant but you're like oh but
this is not a constant well the problem
is a little bit higher up in that when
we created this array of pop-up menu
items we said that is a constant so
let's remove that okay
so that's fantastic and that is i mean
now we're pretty much done
in the entire application we don't have
anything any string that is hard coded
and if you look at our problems
section there are no problems to fix for
instance no unused imports so we've
taken care of those as well and just to
test this what we could do is just to go
to the settings screen here and i'm
going to bring swedish up
and let's go back to our application
here and have a look and it says no
notes yet i'm going to press the plus
button and i'm going to write some
string
go back here it says one note
create a new one and it says two notes
delete this one and all the you see all
the dialogues are now in swedish yes
delete this note
yes let's try to log out now and it says
log look at it
and it says look go to add a second by
the way look at it are you sure you want
to log out yes log out and you can see
all our strings here basically are also
um
everything in this screen is also
localized so that's fantastic
we basically did what we
were supposed to do and what we promised
to do and that is great congratulations
if you then and do what we usually do at
the end of every chapter we
commit our work so i'm gonna have a look
at this and let's have a look at our
good status
and have a look at our git log as well
i'm gonna change the screen layout a
little bit sorry about that so you see
the code better
remove scr cpy make this full screen
okay i'm gonna
make this a lot larger so you see better
and have a look at git log again and you
can see the last one we did git step
sorry step 31 so let's just say git add
all hit commits
that 32
okay
and get status
great and then we're also going to get
push our changes
and let's tag it as well get tagged
step 32
and if you look at our tag
all our tags we can see 20 blah blah
let's see if we have 31 30 31 and 32
great and then we have to push our tags
as well
fantastic so
um
what we've done so far is i mean we've
done a lot of work and in this chapter
even more we've localized our
application we looked at how
localization works how code generation
for localization works and also we had a
look at some
important extensions that you can create
in order to make your localizations even
work better for flutter and we also had
a look at adding some logic to our arb
file with pluralization so
congratulations for going through this
chapter i believe personally that is
very important to localize your
applications you're going to reach a lot
more users if you localize your
applications correctly for your
for like your target markets
and um it should help your users also
feel more connected to your application
so
um with that said i may actually then
see you in the next chapter
hello everyone i can't say welcome to
this chapter now because this is not
really a chapter on its own rather it is
the outro to this course and i don't
know it's a kind of a bittersweet moment
because uh i've had so much fun putting
this course together for you and now i
have to say goodbye and
um
i don't want to get emotional but it is
kind of sad uh as it is a great moment
of
appreciation for you having gone through
this course and also i want to really
extend like
and
congratulate you for having gone through
this course and having learned as
as you've learned because it's it's not
an easy thing to do to go through such a
lengthy course but as i mentioned in the
beginning of this um
course if you remember in the
introduction i mentioned that um
a lot of videos basically jump over
quite a lot of information and i didn't
want to do that in this course and
that's why this course has become
as
lengthy and long as it has
so
we've gone through a lot we've talked
not only about
flutter development but we've also
got our hands dirty with some
native ios and not really development
but all actually going to xcode and
fiddling around with some properties in
info plus an excel project we've also
had to open android studio to create our
virtual devices we've worked with
figma and design tool we work with app
store connect and google play store
console so
we've gone through a lot so and i want
to congratulate you for sticking
throughout all this with me and
um hopefully you've also learned a lot
now while designing this course i also
knew that it has to be a living material
it can't just be something that i drop
out on the internet so i'm very much
planning to keep everything up to date
but there's lots and lots that i've
already planned
more to be added to this course so
i can't really go into details about
what they are i haven't finalized them
but just as i did with this course i
need to plan them correctly write all my
scripts to know what i'm going to talk
about and plan even the code that i need
to write to tell you all about so
just know that there's a lot more to
come
and
you can just subscribe to my youtube
channel if you want to keep up to date
talking about up to date um
things are moving all the time we've
been working with firebase for instance
and firebase in itself is a moving
product so it's an update like ever
it's just always updating so new
versions come out new versions of
flutter might come up come out and new
versions of dart might come out so even
figma for instance that we've been using
a lot the interface might change
erratically so
since i put so much effort into creating
this course i don't want it to die and
i'm not going to let it die so it's
always going to be updating every now
and then i will be putting
and not only updated content out like
maybe i need to replace some old content
with some new but i'm also planning on
adding more to it so
let's just say that this course is gonna
hopefully always be up to date
as i mentioned in the introduction of
this course i have zero dollars
in a budget for
marketing this course and marketing is
probably the wrong word because i don't
actually earn any money by having this
course the only thing i earn is joy of
having
um like people like you going through
this course and telling me on social
media perhaps about oh hey i did this
course and i learned this and this and
this and i've released my first
application so
since i have um no budget for that i
would really appreciate it if you could
spread the word about it and tell like
if someone asked okay i need a course
for learning flutter
uh it would be lovely and i would really
appreciate it if you could just tell
them about this course
and um i've mentioned this also in the
introduction but i would really
appreciate it if you could follow me on
social media twitter at van.np and also
on linkedin because i produce quite a
lot of content
and as infographics for instance also
adds videos related to flutter
javascript python django react native
swift you name it so even typescript now
these days so
uh i would really appreciate it if you
could follow me on social media
and uh i've been told in some places
that um by some some of you that
maybe some people can actually support
me and if you want to do that this is
the way to do it just going to
buy me a
coffee.com but remember it is completely
optional it's only if you can afford it
so with all that said i don't want to
drag on this outro i just want to say
again a huge congratulations to you for
going through this course with me and
spending your life during these so many
hours together with me and i've had a
blast recording all these videos and uh
i'm sure this is not a good buy but
rather an official end basically to this
course and keep an eye out for more
content and i'm sure we'll talk to each
other on social media